If you're interested in learning
about blockchain, this is the
course for you. Patrick Collins
is a veteran software engineer
and longtime finance industry
developer. Be sure to leave a
comment with something you
learned from this course.
Welcome to the ultimate solidity
smart contract and blockchain
Developer course, JavaScript
addition, we recently did a
version of this video in Python
that has over 2 million views
right now making it the most
watched smart contract tutorial
on the planet. We've learned a
ton from doing that first
course. And if you love the
Python language, definitely be
sure to check that one out.
We've taken all the learnings
we've got from making that first
course, wrapped it up and put it
into this JavaScript video for
you. If you're looking to get
started in web three blockchain
smart contracts or any of these
terms, this is the course for
you. And it's for anybody and
everybody, no matter your
experience level in programming
or in blockchain. Ideally, you
know, a little bit of JavaScript
before starting this. But if you
don't, no worries, we will help
you along the way. And in case
you do want to learn a little
bit of JavaScript before
starting here, there are some
fantastic courses on Free Code
Camp to learn more, but you
absolutely don't have to. And
really, any experience with any
object oriented programming
language will work, right. So if
you're brand new to coding, or
if you're brand new to
blockchain, this is exactly
where you should be. And if you
already know a lot about
blockchain or coding, this
course will give you even more
deep fundamentals on the space.
So welcome to the edge of the
rabbit hole. So for those of you
who don't know, my name is
Patrick Collins. I'm a smart
contract engineer, developer
advocate on the chain link
protocol. And I live in breed
smart contracts. I also make
YouTube videos on my own
channel, medium Twitter threads
and more. teaching people about
smart contracts about coding and
about this new technology. I
love helping developers learn,
grow and learn about this new
Advent. That's blockchain and
smart contracts. And I'll be
taking you on your journey to
becoming a blockchain expert and
Wizard of the smart contract
developing world. And even if
you don't want to become a
developer, the first section our
blockchain basics, will give you
a lot of fundamental knowledge
about how blockchain and smart
contracts, even work. I am so
excited for you to be here. And
I hope you enjoy the journey.
This is a data dump, passion
educational project of
everything I've learned working
in this space. And I am 100%
certain that if you follow
along, you'll come out the other
side of this, armed with the
knowledge to be a positive force
in this incredible industry,
solidity and smart contract
developers are massively in
demand with an average salary of
being around $145,000 a year,
there is massive economic
opportunity from learning this
course. And this technology has
the ability to revolutionize
everything that we interact
with, and you can be one of the
pioneers ushering in this new
age. In our courses. We already
have a track record of giving
people these educational needs
and sending them into their
careers in the blockchain and
smart contract space. And we are
going to give you all of the
cutting edge tools and how to
use them including working with
things like D phi NF TS Dows,
ERC 20s upgradable, smart
contracts and more. We're going
to teach you the skills
necessary to build defy
applications like Ave synthetics
and compound, billion dollar
decentralized applications, or
massively successful NFT
projects like crypto punks, or
board apes. Dow is like maker
Dow or developer, Dow and any of
the amazing things you've seen
in the cryptocurrency world. In
learning these skills, you will
have all these economic
opportunities at your fingertips
and the ability to be a pioneer
in completely changing the way
we interact with each other. In
a fundamental way. Building
decentralized smart contract
applications is building a world
that's more accountable a world
with unbreakable promises, a
faster, more efficient,
financially free world, a
collaborative community,
combining the prowess of
philosophy and technology into a
new system. We'll learn more
about the purpose and the value
of smart contracts and
decentralized applications in
lesson one of this course, and
why they're so exciting. Finish
this course. And you'll be
ready. So again, I want to give
a major thank you and a major
kudos to you because you've
taken the first step to enter
this realm. So welcome to Web
three. Welcome to the
blockchain. Welcome to smart
contracts. And I'll see you at
the bottom of the rabbit hole.
So let's jump into some best
practices for this course so
that you can learn most
effectively and learn with this
course as best you can.
You do not want to skip
this part. It'll help you solve
80% of your issue. Now, while
going through this course be
100% certain to follow along
with a GitHub repository
associated with this course we
have a link in the description
of this video for you to
absolutely click on follow along
have open in a tab as you're
doing this because it has all
the code Sam polls, timestamps a
community to interact with and
more, it is going to be your
Bible for watching this course.
And yes, we have a Discussions
tab. This Discussions tab is a
place where you can ask
questions, engage with other
developers who are going through
this course as well. Get some
help, and etc. Be sure to say
hello and meet other like minded
individuals like yourselves.
Now, blockchain and smart
contracts move really quickly.
And things are constantly being
updated. So to make sure you're
always up to date with the
latest, when I open up some
documentation, try to open up
the documentation for yourself
as well. And maybe even have the
code sample next to you. And as
you're writing code, be sure to
refer back to make sure that you
are keeping pace, and then you
have the most up to date
samples, sometimes technology
might change, and there might be
a way to do something a little
bit better. So we have this file
called chronological updates, be
sure that this is the first
place to check when you run into
an issue to see if maybe
something was updated that you
missed, it'll be chronologically
ordered. So it's easier to find
updates. Basically, this is to
say, always refer back to the
GitHub repo first. And if you do
to find a mistake, or something
isn't working the way you
expected, jump into the
conversation, leave a
discussion, leave an issue, ask
questions here, take breaks, I
cannot tell you how many people
tried rushing through our entire
first course in one setting and
didn't retain as much
information, your brain
remembers information much
better if you take breaks. So
every 25 minutes or half an
hour, maybe take a five minute
walk. And then every two hours
take a much longer break. And if
you really want to make sure
something drills in, try to go
back and reflect on what you did
for the lesson prior before
continuing to the next lesson.
And at the same time, though,
learn at your own speed. There
is no right speed for this
course. If it takes you a day, a
week, a month or even a year, it
doesn't matter. Learn at the
pace that's right for you, you
can change the speed at which I
talked using the little gear
icon in the YouTube video. If
I'm talking way too fast for
you, you can slow me down. And
at the same time, if I'm talking
too slow, you can speed me up,
you also don't even have to go
in order. You can bounce around
topic to topic, if you don't
want to learn full stack, you
can skip the full stack stuff.
If you don't want to learn
coding, we can skip the coding
stuff. If you only want to go to
the advanced stuff, go to the
advanced stuff. You are highly
encouraged to pause, come back
and ask questions. The
blockchain and smart contract
world is incredibly
collaborative. So be sure to use
tools like the discussions tab
of our GitHub repository, asking
questions on Stack Overflow and
Aetherium Stack Exchange and
tagging relative technologies,
making issues on different
GitHub repositories that you're
working with jumping into
discord, Reddit, Twitter, and
any other place that these
communities and technologies are
congregating. And the reason I'm
putting so much emphasis on
these community aspects is that
becoming a solidity and
blockchain engineer is so much
more than just the solidity
part. Being comfortable with all
the tools in this space,
including the ones to get help
and to give help are essential
to being successful here.
Networking is massive, and it
makes it a ton of fun. As you
continue your journey and you
get more advanced and you're
looking for places to meet other
developers. Hackathons are one
of the best places to connect
with other engineers, the
chainlink hackathons eath,
global hackathons, and Dev folio
hackathons are three great
hackathon suites to connect. And
no matter where you are in your
journey, they're great places to
flex what you've learned.
Alright, so those are some of
the best practices for this
course. You're standing at the
edge of the rabbit hole, looking
down, peering into the world of
web three and smart contracts
and blockchain. If you're like
me want to jump in, you want to
keep going further. Let's begin
our journey into the world of
smart contracts. And it all
starts with the blockchain
basics.
Now, I know you're excited
to get coding. But before we
jump in, we want to learn some
of the fundamentals of
blockchains and smart contracts.
Understanding these ideologies
and these basics are so
important, because it'll dictate
how you architect your
decentralized applications,
learning the basics of
blockchain and solidity is
critical. But if you already
know the basics of a blockchain,
feel free to jump into lesson
two.
Now, since you're here,
you've probably heard of Bitcoin
before. Bitcoin was one of the
first protocols to use this
revolutionary technology called
blockchain. The Bitcoin white
paper was created by the pseudo
anonymous Satoshi Nakamoto, and
outlined how Bitcoin can make
peer to peer transactions. In a
decentralized network. This
network was powered by
cryptography, decent Tality, and
allowed people to engage in
censorship resistant finance, in
a decentralized manner due to
its features, which we'll talk
about in a little bit. People
took to this as a superior
digital store of value, a better
store of value over something
like gold, for example, and
that's why you'll also hear
people commonly refer to it as a
digital gold similar to gold.
There's a scarce amount or a set
amount of bitcoin available on
the planet, only so much that
you can buy and sell. You can
read more about the original
vision in the white A paper
we've linked to the white paper
in the GitHub repo associated
with this course. Now, this was
an insane breakthrough in a
little bit, we're going to learn
exactly how this is all possible
and how this actually works
under the hood. Some people
though, saw this technology and
wanted to take it a little bit
farther, and do even more with
this blockchain technology. And
a few years later, a man named
Vitalik Buterin, released a
white paper for a new protocol
named Aetherium, which use this
same blockchain infrastructure
with an additional feature. And
in 2015, him and a number of
other co founders released the
project Aetherium, where people
could not only make
decentralized transactions, but
decentralized agreements,
decentralized organizations, and
all these other ways to interact
with each other without a
centralized intermediary or
centralized governing force.
Basically, their idea was to
take this thing that made
Bitcoin so great, and add
decentralized agreements to it,
or smart contracts. And in fact,
technically, these smart
contracts weren't even really a
new idea. Back in 1994, a man
named Nick Zabo, had actually
originally come up with the idea
smart contracts are a set of
instructions executed in a
decentralized autonomous way,
without the need for a third
party or centralized body to run
them. And they come to life on
these blockchains, or these
smart contract platforms, like
Aetherium. And it's the smart
contracts that are going to be
the core thing that we're going
to be working on in this course,
and that we're going to be
developing, you can think of
smart contracts in the same way
you think of traditional
contracts or traditional
agreements. They're just a set
of instructions between parties,
except instead of written on pen
and paper or typed up in
Microsoft Word, they are written
in code and embodied on these
decentralized blockchain
platforms. And that's also where
they're executed. Instead of
being executed by the two
parties, or three parties, or
however many parties that are
involved. This removes this
centralized issue that we'll
talk about more in a bit. This
is one of the main
differentiators between the
Etherium protocol and the
Bitcoin protocol. It's these
smart contracts. Now,
technically, bitcoin does have
smart contracts, but they're
intentionally Turing incomplete,
which means they don't have all
the functionality that a
programming language would give
them. This was an intentional
move by Bitcoin developers.
Bitcoin developers viewed
Bitcoin as a store of value
versus Aetherium, developers
viewed Aetherium as both a store
of value and a utility to
facilitate these decentralized
agreements. Now, the smart
contracts on blockchains alone
are absolutely incredible.
However, they do come with a
huge issue. If we want these
digital agreements to replace
the agreements in our everyday
lives, they probably are going
to need data from the real world
blockchains by themselves
actually can't interact with and
can't read or listen to data
from the real world. This is
what's known as the Oracle
problem. These blockchains are
deterministic systems and
they're deterministic on
purpose. And we'll learn about
more about how that works in the
sessions to come. So everything
that happens with them happens
in their little world. But if
they're going to be these
agreements, they need external
data and they need external
computation. And this is where
Oracle's come into play.
Oracle's are any device that
delivers data to these
decentralized blockchain or runs
external computation. However,
if we want our applications to
stay truly decentralized, we
can't work with a single Oracle
or a single data provider or a
single source that's running
these external computations. So
we need a decentralized Oracle
network. Similar to our
decentralized blockchain
network, you're on chain logic
will be decentralized, but you
also need your off chain data
and computation be
decentralized, combining this on
chain decentralized logic. With
this off chain, decentralized
data and decentralized
computation gives rise to
something called hybrid smart
contracts. And most of the
biggest protocols that we
interact with today are some
type of hybrid smart contract or
interact with hybrid smart
contracts. To some extent, this
is where the protocol chaining
comes into play. It is a
modular, decentralized Oracle
network that can both bring
external data and external
computation into our smart
contracts to make sure they're
decentralized end to end, while
giving them the feature richness
that we need for our agreements.
chainlink allows for us to get
data to upkeeps, get random
numbers or really customize our
smart contracts in any
meaningful way. Now, throughout
the course, we're going to use
the terminology smart contract.
However, whenever we say smart
contract, we're often using it a
little interchangeably with
hybrid smart contracts, but just
know that when we say hybrid
smart contract, we're talking
specifically about smart
contracts that have some type of
off chain component. Now since
the theorems release, a number
of different block chains or
smart contract platforms have
come to light such as avalanche
polygon, Phantom harmony, and
more. For the majority of this
course, we're going to be
assuming that we're going to be
deploying to the Ethereum
network. However, everything
that we learned here is going to
be applicable to the vast
majority of the blockchains out
there like polygon, avalanche,
Phantom harmony, etc, and
understanding everything from a
theory and funding mentals will
give you the skills that you
need to switch chains very
easily with literally one line
of code. So don't worry about
learning a specific tool or with
a specific chain because most of
them work together seamlessly.
Now, there are a couple of smart
contract platforms that don't
use solidity. But still learning
the fundamentals here will make
you much better at those as
well. And the Etherium by far
has the most value locked and is
the most used blockchain and
smart contract platform out
there. You'll also hear those
two terms used a little bit
interchangeably as well.
Sometimes they'll say smart
contract platform, sometimes
they'll say blockchain, they
kind of mean the same thing.
Obviously, blockchains could
mean store of value and smart
contract platform, but you get
the idea. Similarly, chainlink
is the most popular and powerful
decentralized Oracle network is
the one that we're going to be
focusing on for this course as
well. chainlink is also
blockchain agnostic. So to work
on Aetherium, avalanche, Polygon
Solana Terra, or really any
other blockchain out there. Now,
throughout this course, you'll
hear the term DAP or
decentralized Protocol, or smart
contract Protocol, or
decentralized application. And
they all kind of mean the same
thing. A decentralized
application is usually the
combination of many smart
contracts. And when we get into
solidity, you'll see what a
singular smart contract really
looks like. And like I said,
learning all these core
fundamentals will make you a
better solidity and a better
smart contract developer, you'll
also hear the term web three a
lot in this video. And in the
industry, web three is the idea
that blockchain and smart
contracts are the next iteration
of the web web one being this
permissionless open source world
with static content, web two
being the permissioned web with
dynamic content, but all the
agreements and logic runs off of
centralized servers where they
control your information. And
then web three comes back to the
permissionless web. But once
again, with dynamic content, and
instead of centralized servers,
running your logic,
decentralized networks, run the
logic creating these censorship
resistant agreements, that the
smart contracts enable is also
generally accompanied by the
idea that the users own the
protocols that they work with,
and it's an ownership economy.
You'll see what I mean later in
this course. And we've talked a
lot about the history and about
the high level of these
protocols and of the smart
contracts and what they can do.
But what do these smart
contracts really mean? What is
it when I say trust, minimize
agreements or unbreakable
promises? What is the real value
add of these smart contracts?
Before we look under the hood,
take a peek at how this all
works. From a technical
standpoint. Let's learn what all
the value of this is. What is
the purpose of us building all
these technologies? Have you
taken this course? What problem
does this technology solve? In
my mind, a technology is really
only as good as the problem that
it solves. If it doesn't solve a
problem, then why bother Mark
contracts, Blockchain web three
cryptocurrencies, those are all
just different words that
encapsulate the idea of what
we're doing in such a unique
paradigm. I think the easiest
way to sum up what these smart
contracts do is that they create
trust minimized agreements. And
if you might be scratching your
head to that. A much easier way
to think about it is just that
give rise to unbreakable
promises. Yes, you heard that
right. Unbreakable agreements
and promises. Additionally, they
give rise to speed, efficiency
and transparency, and a number
of other things. I made a video
pretty recently about exactly
this. So let's dive in and take
a listen to the purpose the
undeniable value
of smart contracts
cryptocurrencies, fundamentally
re landscape markets and
agreements as we know them.
Unfortunately, you've probably
only been bombarded with people
screaming about empties and
money. Now, some of the memes
are fun, but let's forget the
bullet and get down to the
essence of the space. If you're
already in web three. This is
the video to send to your
friends to explain why you're so
excited about this space and
explain why we're here. And then
if you're not into crypto,
you've come to the right place.
And yes, there are fun memes and
markets and there's some money
stuff in there all these things.
But outside of all that the
purpose of blockchains relates
to the age old elementary school
unbreakable, promise the pinky
swear, let's get Froggy. Nearly
everything you do in life is the
result of an agreement or a
contract. Your chair was the
result of an agreement to buy
and sell lumber to assemble and
sell the chair to a real tailor
on Amazon. Then you made an
agreement to buy the chair for
$40. The lights in your house
are powered by electricity,
which is an agreement from you
and the electric company you
agree to pay them in return
they'll keep the lights on the
electricity they generate it's
agreements between them and
engineers who built turbines to
generate the electricity with
insurance you agree to pay some
amount of money to them every
month, and in return, they will
do nothing or I mean, they'll
cover your medical bills, almost
everything you do and everything
you interact with is the result
of some form of agreement or
contract in some aspect. Now,
agreements and contracts can
feel kind of abstract and boring
to really grasp on to simplify,
we can also refer to them as
promises. When you get an oil
change. They're promising that
they will faithfully change your
oil In exchange for money, when
you put money in the bank, they
promise to keep it safe in
exchange for them to use your
money to give out loans. When
you buy a lottery ticket, the
lottery promises to give you a
fair chance at winning a ton of
money in exchange for you buying
the ticket. Whenever you make
one of these agreements. In a
way, you're asking them to pinky
swear to not screw you over and
to treat you fairly. But this
doesn't always happen. Let's
look at a real world example of
someone breaking the Pinkie
swear back in the 80s and 90s,
McDonald's ran a promotion for
people to win money by
collecting McDonald's Monopoly
game cards. The idea was simple.
You buy McDonald's in return,
you get a chance to win $1
million. You can imagine
McDonald's literally going Hey,
everybody, I promise you if you
buy our MC food and McNuggets,
we'll give you a fair chance of
winning this money, we ended up
breaking this promise, instead
of having a fair chance of
winning your chance was in fact,
zero in the mid 90s. Between 13
and $24 million went into the
pockets of not people playing
the game, honestly. But a group
of corrupt insiders who had
rigged the game, meaning that
when you played the McDonald's
Monopoly game, you were buying
into a set of lies and promises
that were 100% always going to
be broken. And the thing is, it
doesn't really matter if this
was McDonald's fault or not.
They were the ones making the
promises that they ultimately
could not keep. Another way you
could think about it is that
that's $24 million that they
essentially stole from you and I
now if this system was deployed
on a blockchain was something
called a smart contract, it
would have been impossible to
defraud this $24 million due to
smart contracts being immutable,
decentralized and transparent.
But I'll get back to that in a
minute. In all the agreements
and contracts we make, imagine
making a pinky swear with a 10
year old and imagining how that
agreement would hold up. Hey,
buddy, Could you could you
please keep my money safe? You
can play with it if you like,
but just please have it when I
come back. Immediately. You
might get that worrying feeling
in your chest, something might
go wrong. This 10 year old might
lose your money. You might be
thinking, how could I trust
them? Will they break their
promise and this feeling of I
can't breathe because of
untrustworthy situations
happens? Once all the time. Can
I trust this used car
salesperson to give me a good
car? Can I trust this tag that
says machine washable? Or will
it make my shirt shrink? Will my
insurance provider break their
promise of covering my medical
bills want to get hit by a bus?
I'm Patrick promises he'll go on
a hike with me. Well, he
actually I actually will. But
the issue with our current
agreements and contracts is we
have to trust the people. We're
making them to do the right
thing. However often they're
actually incentivized to not do
the right thing. insurance
doesn't want to pay out money.
Sometimes salespeople just want
to get the shit off the shelves
and with my girlfriend, I
promised to go on a hike. But I
need hikes. Where else is has
happened. Now you might be
thinking okay, Patrick, this
seems cool. But like Where has
this actually affected me? Well,
the McDonald's lottery that we
just spoke about above during
the Great Depression with the
run of the banks banks promised
to keep our money safe and that
when we went back to go get it
they would actually have the
money there. And well and behold
there were times that they
didn't have the money they're
just last year Robin Hood
painted this amazing picture. On
user application we will give
you access to the markets we
promise we will give you a
retail investor a fair chance of
interacting with the world the
finance
side, but not this asset. This
asset, this asset or this asset,
the 2008 financial crisis
remember that shady deals behind
closed doors combined with lies
about financial product brought
the world to its economic knees,
how are you? hyperinflation in
Zimbabwe hyperinflation in
Brazil, fair enough. US history
is a relentless lesson of
trustworthy entities being
notorious promised breakers and
we finally have a way to fix it
with smart contracts. Now,
before I jump into smart
contracts, a lot of people might
be thinking, hey, cool in all,
however, we have systems in
place to protect against a lot
of these things, which is true,
and which is great. And that is
a very helpful step forward. But
these systems often breaks ones
in 2008 Definitely didn't work.
The ones with the Robin Hood
crisis definitely didn't work.
And even if these systems apply,
and you go to court to try to
work them out, maybe you're in
court for years before you
actually see a resolution and by
that time, what you needed the
money for is longer. So what is
this technology? What is this
tool that can fix this
fundamental problem in our
agreements today, this tool is
smart contracts and this tool is
what the blockchain was built
for. Now, I'm gonna give you a
quick overview of what a smart
contract is. However, I'm
leaving some links in the
description for more in depth
explanations, but the basics of
them is a smart contract is an
agreement contract or a set of
instructions deployed on a
decentralized blockchain. And
once the contract or set of
instructions is deployed, it
cannot be altered, it
automatically executes and
everyone can see the terms of
the agreement. Real basics of it
is that the code is executed by
decentralized collective like a
group of people but a group of
people running a certain
software. This means that no one
person or entity can actually
alter any of these agreements or
change the terms of the
arrangement in these traditional
agreements. Whoever owns the
contract, whoever owns the
execution of the contract can
flip a switch and say, We're not
going to do that anymore. In
smart contracts and web three in
blockchain, you no longer can do
that. Typically, these smart
contracts are on a decentralized
blockchain, and used in
combination with a decentralized
Oracle network to get the real
world assets and information.
And if these words sound like
I'm conjuring up a magic spell,
well, again, check the links in
the description. If you want to
learn more about the technical
implications. If you're not a
technical person, then you're
not interested in getting into
the nitty gritty, you can kind
of think of it like HTTPS, I bet
the vast majority of you don't
even know what HTTPS stands for.
And yet you use it every single
day whenever you log on to the
internet. So how does this fix
the McDonald's Monopoly issue?
In its traditional form, the
lottery was executed behind
closed doors, somebody operated
and owned the code and the
contracts and the agreements
that ran the lottery, and they
had the power to alter it. And
nobody other than the people
internal on the lottery could
audit this altering happening.
Now if the code for this lottery
was deployed onto a blockchain,
every time a hacker attempted to
alter it, everyone would be
notified. Not only that, but you
couldn't even alter it, because
the terms of a smart contract
cannot be altered. Once
deployed, combine that smart
contract with a chain link VRF
Oracle to get a verifiably
random number. And presto, you
now have a perfectly
decentralized, unalterable
agreement that is impossible to
hack commit fraud or manipulate
we have just saved the public
between 13,000,020 $4 million
just by fixing the issue of
trust. How does this fix Robin
Hood? Well, the problem with
Robin Hood is already fixed.
Right? Again, the problem is
that there's a centralized body
that can flip a switch at any
time and say you can't access
these markets anymore. We're
breaking our promise of actually
giving you access to the
markets. This is already fixed
with something called
decentralized exchanges. And
these exist today, one of these
exchanges is one called uniswap.
You can swap ERC 20 tokens,
which are kind of the equivalent
of stocks, but some are some
are, it's a little confusing. I
won't get into that here either.
But it doesn't have that
centralized body that can flip a
switch and ruin access to the
markets. And had these investors
been on a decentralized
exchange, it would have saved
them hundreds of millions of
dollars, and it would have
prevented fraudulent market
manipulation. How does it fix
run of the banks with
transparency built in an
automated solvency checks, you
can build a bank like smart
contract that has insolvency
checks built in that make it
impossible to get there and
solve it means brokers any
agreement or any history lesson,
where there was a trust
assumption that was broken,
smart contracts can be applied
to and should be applied to,
especially in a time where big
money runs, owns and controls
everything, we desperately need
to move to a world where some
self interested centralized
entity can't flip a switch and
ruin people's access to the
services that they need. We can
move away from a world that is
brand based to a world that is
math based. Right now, if you
interact with a service that you
don't like, or that they break
their promise, the only thing
you can do is walk down the
street to the next service
that's going to make the same
set of promises. And you have to
hope and pray that they're
actually going to keep it we can
move from that to a world where
we can just look at the map and
say, oh, okay, one plus one
equals two. This is what this
agreement is going to do for me
every single time guaranteed,
because it's a decentralized
autonomous agent has no
incentive to be evil, and
everything is transparent and
out in the open of a big
company. And if it was better
for me for one plus one to equal
three, maybe I would go behind
some closed doors and flood some
numbers and come back and be
like, hey, one plus one equals
three with smart contracts.
That's impossible. Doing the
right thing is infrastructural
now, given the choice between
two agreements, one where you
have to trust a single
centralized entity that they're
going to do the right thing for
you, versus a decentralized
untampered double collective,
which one you're gonna choose.
I'm picking the one that can't
screw me over every single time.
For every agreement I can apply
it to now this technology is
relatively new, but we have
already seen it relandscaping
entire markets and continue to
do so the traditional financial
world is already getting its
lunch eaten by defy or
decentralized finance. There's
already over $200 billion of
people's money in these
protocols to help have a more
fair, more accountable, more
transparent financial system.
This defy movement is one of the
main reasons I got into this
space because we desperately
need to move away from where we
are right now. And and people's
chances for wealth being sucked
up by some group that's bending
the rules in their favor and
smart contracts are our ticket
to that better world. More and
more industries are also coming
over to smart contracts and
blockchain because of all the
innovations and because of all
the advantages that it has as we
grow and as we get better as we
get closer to this vision of
having this concept fulfilled,
trust minimized agreements.
These smart contracts are
minimizing the trust that we
need to give other people in
order for these agreements to be
executed. If trust minimized
agreements is too confusing for
you just say unbreakable
promises. Now I gotta be honest
with you guys. blockchains and
smart contracts and
cryptocurrencies can actually do
more than just trust, minimize
agreements. They have security
benefits, uptime benefits,
execution, speed benefits, and a
whole lot more. But it's a lot
easier to just learn about one
and learn the other ones later,
right. It's kind of like
sprinkles on top. So this is why
we are here. This is why we're
building this future and this is
why we are so excited about it.
Even in just this introduction
part, we've learned a ton. So
let's do a quick summary of what
we've learned so far. Bitcoin
was the first protocol to take
this blockchain technology into
the limelight and take these
cryptocurrencies into the
mainstream Bitcoin is a sort of
digital gold or a store of value
able to make transactions
between users in a decentralized
manner. Aetherium and other
smart contract platforms take
this blockchain technology one
step further, enabling people to
make smart contracts and
decentralized trust minimized
agreements, the smart contracts
and decentralized applications
can access and interact with the
real world using something
called decentralized Oracle
networks. chain link is a
decentralized network that
allows us to build these hybrid
smart contracts, which combines
our on chain logic with our off
chain, decentralized data, and
decentralized computation,
giving rise to our logic being
completely decentralized, and
our data and external
computation being completely
decentralized, giving us all the
features that traditional
agreements and traditional
contracts have. Now these
digital currencies like
Aetherium, and Bitcoin have
value. Even without the smart
contract part, having a
censorship resistant,
decentralized store of value is
naturally powerful in its own
right, we have some links in the
GitHub repository that will
teach you how this decentralized
store of value flips traditional
finance on its head. And it's
another one of the great reasons
for building smart contracts.
But again, the easiest way to
boil it down is trust minimized
agreements, or unbreakable
promises. But let's also go into
some of these other features
that smart contracts have over
our traditional environment. The
first feature, of course, is
that they are decentralized. And
they have no centralized
intermediary, the different
individuals that run one of
these blockchains are known as
node operators. And it's the
combination of all these 1000s
of node operators running the
same software running these
algorithms running these smart
contracts that make the network
decentralized. We'll dive deeper
into how that works later. The
next feature is transparency and
flexibility in these
decentralized networks. Since
all these individual node
operators run the software,
everybody can see everything
that's happening on chain,
meaning there's no shady deals,
there's no weird things
happening. Anything that's going
to be unfair, people will be
able to see and just not use,
everybody has perfect
information and has to play by
the same rules. Now
additionally, this doesn't mean
that there's no privacy, the
blockchain is pseudo anonymous,
meaning that you aren't
necessarily tied to an identity
in real life, they also have the
feature of speed and efficiency.
For those of you who have ever
tried to do a bank transfer or
send money across seas, you
know, it sometimes can take two
to three weeks, when in fact,
all these banks are really doing
is basic math. They're
subtracting money from your
balance and adding it to some
other balance. Why does it take
so long, in the blockchain, all
of these transactions happen
instantly. Another instance for
those in the financial world
today know that clearing houses
and settlement days can take a
long time. In the blockchain,
there's no need for any of that,
because they happen instantly.
This obviously is much quicker,
but it also makes for much more
efficient interactions with each
other security and immutability.
Again, immutable means that it
can't be changed. Once a smart
contract is deployed, that's it,
whatever is in the code is going
to be in the code forever, they
cannot be altered or tampered
with in any way. This means that
the security is much easier.
Whereas in a centralized world,
somebody can hack into the
server, jump into the database
and change some numbers. You
can't do that in the blockchain
world. And since it's
decentralized, in order to hack
the blockchain, you'd have to
take over half of the nodes as
opposed to in the centralized
world, where you only have to
take over one in the regular
world. If your computer and your
backup computer go down, all of
your data is gone. In the
blockchain world, if your
computer and your backup
computer go down, all your data
is safe, because it's being run
on all these other decentralized
nodes. And even if a few 100
nodes or a few 1000 nodes go
down. It doesn't matter because
as long as one node has a copy
of the blockchain, you're good
to go hacking a blockchain is
nearly impossible, and leaps and
bounds more difficult than
hacking a centralized server.
Not only that, but this is safer
in the asset sense as well. All
you need to access your
credentials and your information
in your assets is your private
key. Which is basically your
password for all of this. And as
we've discussed in the video,
the smart contracts remove this
counterparty risk, remove this
centralized intermediary, remove
these trust gateways that we
have to do in web two. When we
engage with users and
individuals, they don't always
have our best interests at heart
smart contracts, remove this
counterparty risk, because once
one of these contracts is
created, they can't go in and
they can't alter it. And they
can't let greed or ego or
anything else, get the better of
them and alter the terms of the
deal. And as we said, this gives
rise to these trust minimized
agreements or these programmatic
unbreakable promises. We move
away from brand based agreements
to math based agreements, where
we can look at the cryptography
we can look right at the code
and see exactly what something
is going to do and how it's
going to execute, versus having
to rely on a human being doing
the right thing with smart
contracts and decentralized
hybrid smart contracts. Doing
the right thing is
infrastructural all these pieces
boil down to us having the
freedom to interact the way we
want to interact without having
to be afraid that interacting
like that is going to screw us
over this trust minimized piece,
these unbreakable promises, make
interactions so much better. In
a purely web two world, we're
constantly bombarded with
messages of projects and
protocols pushing us to move or
act in the direction that makes
them more profitable. Versus in
the smart contract space,
we can see everything
transparently. And we can even
engage in interact and be
partially owners of the
protocols and the interactions
that we decide that we want to
be a part
of. So smart contracts have
been around for a few years now.
And what did they generate for
what industries have come about
due to these smart contract
platforms being around? Well,
you've probably heard of some of
these and some of these we've
already mentioned, but let's
give you a quick refresher, d
phi d phi stands for
decentralized finance. And it
gives users the ability to
engage with finance and markets
without having to go through a
centralized intermediary. For
example, like we said, with
Robin Hood, you no longer have
to trust that Robin Hood would
continue to give you access to
the markets, you instead would
be able to see in the smart
contract. Yes, I have access to
the markets or in the 2008
financial crisis. You never have
to trust that these groups and
institutions are giving you the
correct things on the back end.
You can see everything
transparently right on the
blockchain, you can engage with
things like money markets and
sophisticated financial products
easy effectively and securely at
the time of recording. defi has
around $200 billion in assets
under management and is quickly
growing. If you're really
excited about defy we have a ton
of defy examples showing you how
to build and interact with these
protocols. In coming lessons.
Dows or decentralized.
autonomous organizations are
another group that we've already
mentioned. Dows are groups that
are governed completely
decentralized by a set of
instructions or smart contracts
on chain. There are some massive
benefits here where engagement
is much easier. The rules are
black and white. And you can see
everything directly on chain
voting and governance
technologies completely
decentralized in the blockchain
space is one of the big ones
pushing how we can evolve
politics and how we can evolve
governance to make it more
efficient, fair and reasonable.
And you better know it, we have
some examples of how to build
Dows and how to work with Dows
incoming lessons. So be sure to
watch those NF T's Stanford non
fungible tokens and can really
be kind of described as digital
art or just a unique asset, they
can do so much more, but we'll
keep it high level for now.
Projects like board apes and
crypto punks have revolutionized
the way that people get paid for
their work, show off their
creativity, status, and so much
more. And yes, of course, we
have lessons showing you how to
create and interact with NF T's
as well, so many other groups
and so many other industries are
being created as a result of
this insane technology. And
maybe after finishing the
journey with us here, you go out
and you'd be the one to pioneer
the next industry or the next
billion dollar idea you've
learned so much already. But now
that we've learned a lot of this
high level information, let's
finally jump in, and let's make
your first transaction and let's
get you set up to interact with
this new world. In this next
section, we're going to get you
a wallet and we're going to show
you exactly what a transaction
looks like and feels like. Let's
dive in. This is the Aetherium
website aetherium.org We are
going to make a transaction on a
test Aetherium blockchain I'll
explain what that means in a
little bit. This is going to be
our first transaction that's
made on the blockchain. Now
again, this process that we're
going to follow is going to work
the exact same with polygon,
avalanche Phantom and all these
other EVM compatible
blockchains. I'll explain what
that means in a bit too. For
now, just follow along and have
fun in order to make a
transaction on any of these
blockchains. The first thing
that we need to do is we need to
set up a wallet. So I'm gonna go
ahead and go to meta mask
because it's one of the most
popular wallets and one of the
easiest to Use, we're going to
go ahead and download it. I'm
using the brave browser, but it
works for Chrome, Firefox or
really any other browsers. And
it's just going to be a little
extension in the top right hand
of your browser. This way, we
can really easily see it any
times what we have in our
wallet, will still are all of
our Aetherium based currencies.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
install meta mask for brave,
add to brave, add extension. And
now we can go ahead and get
started with working with Brave,
this is the first step you
absolutely need to take when
starting your journey and one of
the easiest steps to take. So
we're gonna go ahead and get
started. And we're going to
create a brand new wallet. So
we're gonna go ahead and hit
create wallet. If you already
have a wallet, you can actually
import it via I have a seed
phrase, and we'll talk about the
seed phrase or secret phrase in
a little bit. So let's go ahead
and create a new wallet. And
sure, we'll agree to help out
Metamask now we will create our
password make sure that this is
really secure. For the purpose
of this demo, my passwords are
just gonna be password. But
please don't have that be your
password. You may also get a
video like this teaching you
about your secret recovery
phrase. This is the same thing
as your pneumonic. But see your
recovery phrase is a lot more
clear as to what it is. And
again, to give us a ton of
different tips on how to
actually store it and keep it
safe. The main takeaway from
this is never shared this
absolutely never shared this. So
we're going to go ahead and
click reveal secret words. I'm
showing you guys here because
this is just a demo and I don't
really care. However, if you
show this secret phrase to
anybody else, they will have
access to all the funds in your
application. So everything that
we're going to do in this
tutorial, we're going to use
fake money, we're going to use
not real money, so it doesn't
matter. Now for the purposes of
testing and developing, I always
recommend using a completely
separate meta mask, a completely
separate Wallet. So for going
throughout this entire course,
if you already have a wallet, or
if you already have a meta mask,
please just set up a new one,
create a new profile, create a
new meta mask, and this will be
your wallet that you use for the
duration of this course.
However, if you're going to
actually put money in here, you
absolutely need to have this
written down. Because if you
lose access to this, and all
your private keys, which we'll
talk about in a little bit, you
will lose access to your wallet,
and you will lose access to all
your funds. So they give some
tips like store this phrase and
a password manager like one
password, write this phrase down
on a piece of paper, put it in a
secure location, memorize it,
whatever you want to do, just
make sure you have this backed
up somewhere, I'm just gonna go
ahead and hit download this for
now, it's not best practice to
save to your computer, it is
much better to use a password
manager or write it down on a
piece of paper or something. So
we're gonna go ahead and hit
next. And it's going to ask us
to verify that we actually have
it written down. And we're gonna
go ahead and hit confirm, and
great and gives us a couple
other tips. Remember, definitely
take these tips very seriously,
especially if you're gonna use
this for real money. Like I
said, For this demo, we're just
going to use test money. So it's
not as big of a deal. But if you
put real money in, you
absolutely need to backup this
seed phrase or secret phrase or
we're going to refer to it as
our pneumonic phrase. Awesome.
Now we can see the interface of
our wallet here full screen. And
depending on your browser, you
can actually come up and pin it
to your browser so that you can
just click it up in the top
right, and it'll drop down and
you can see the same interface
here our pneumonic phrase that
secret phrase, those that secret
12 words that they gave us have
given us access to a new
account, the address of our
account is located right here.
In fact, if we click it and copy
it to our clipboard, and go to a
tool called a block explorer
called ether scan, we can
actually paste our address in
here and see details about our
account. Ether scan, like I
said, is what's known as a block
Explorer. And it's a way to view
different addresses transactions
and other happenings that happen
with a blockchain. If we look at
this address that we just
created on ether scan for
Etherium main net, we can see no
transactions have happened.
There's really no analytics,
there's no comments, there's no
balance, there's no value,
because it's a brand new wallet,
and this address that we just
punched into ether scan
represents our unique address
our unique wallet only
identifiable for us. We'll talk
about ether scan a little bit
more in a bit because it's a
tool that we're going to use
quite often in wallets like meta
mask, you can actually even
click right here and create even
more accounts. So let's go ahead
and create a new account. We'll
call this
account two.
As you can see, this one has a
different address. So if we
click this one, we go back to
ether scan. We paste the address
in here. We hit Enter. We can
see another address again that's
uniquely identifiable to us,
right here. It is zero balance,
no value, no transactions now If
we go back to our Metamask, and
we click the little button, we
can see we have two different
accounts in here, it's the same.
If we hit the extension in the
top right, click the button, we
have two different accounts. The
12 word secret recovery phrase
allows us to create multiple
accounts, all with the same
secret recovery phrase. So that
secret recovery phrase will give
us access to both account one
and account two and any other
accounts that we create by
hitting this Create Account
button, because it gives you
access to all the accounts in
your meta mask. Now, these
addresses of both of our
accounts are the public unique
identifiers, but they also have
a private unique identifier only
identifiable to us. Similar to
the pneumonic, these are private
identifiers we never want to
share and we never want to give
out their private This is known
as your accounts private key. So
the mnemonic will give you
access over many of these
accounts, the private key will
give you access to just one of
these accounts, we can see it by
hitting these little three dots,
going to account details and
export private key, you'll just
have to punch in your password
here. And you'll be able to see
your private key. This is going
to be your private key for your
account, you can think of your
private key as a password for
your account that lets you
create transactions. Now the
reason that I'm showing mine on
screen is because I'm not going
to put any real money in here.
And this is just going to be a
burner account for this
tutorial. And I highly recommend
once again, you use a burner
account, you use accounts that
you never put any real money
into. And along the way, I'll
show you how to make sure that
you don't do that. But normally,
it's not a good idea to show or
share your private keys or your
secret recovery phrase, if
somebody gets a hold of this
private key, they will have
access to my account one.
However, they won't have access
to my account to if they get a
hold of my 12 word recovery
phrase or pneumonic they'll have
access to both accounts. And
this is why when people say keep
your private keys safe, your
keys, your Bitcoin, your keys,
your Aetherium, they're talking
about both your mnemonics or
your secret recovery phrases.
And your private keys keep those
private, your public addresses
are totally public. And anybody
can view your accounts on
something like ether scan, or
any other explore. And it's
totally okay for people to share
their public addresses. If you
lose your private key, you lose
access to one of your accounts.
If you lose your mnemonic, you
could potentially lose access to
all your accounts. Basically,
what I'm trying to say is back
these up and keep them in safe
places for this course it's okay
if you lose one, since we're not
putting any real money in them.
But in the real world, be sure
to do this. And great. Those are
some of the main security
considerations here. Now, if you
look up in the top right, right
next to that account button that
we've been clicking, you also
see this thing saying Etherium
main net, this is our networks
tab. And if we click it, we can
see a list of all the different
networks that we currently have
access to a Etherium main net is
the main network of Aetherium.
And this is where real money is
spent and used for transactions.
For this course, we're not going
to be working with the Etherium
main net, we're instead going to
be working with something called
a test net. Since we're
engineers, oftentimes, we're
going to want to test and see
what our code is actually going
to do and how to interact with
it. We're going to use a
combination of local networks
and test networks to actually do
this to actually test our smart
contracts. We're mainly going to
use local networks. But we'll
get to that in a little bit to
see some of the test networks
that come default with meta
mask, we hit show slash hide
test networks, this will bring
us into the settings page. And
we just hit select this to show
test networks in the list. And
we just hit on Now if we scroll
back up, we'll close out of the
settings, we hit the network's
tab again. Now we can see all of
these other networks here like
ropsten, Koven, Rinkeby, and
Garelli. These test networks or
networks that resemble
Aetherium, or polygon, or
Avalanche or phantom or any of
these other blockchains. And we
can actually switch our accounts
to one of these other test
networks. Let's click rink B,
for example, we can see that on
the Rinkeby test network. We
also have zero Aetherium we have
no money or nothing in here, we
have a blank Rinkeby wallet.
These test nets work nearly
identical to how Aetherium main
networks except for they run
with not real money. They run
with fake money as a way for us
to learn and interact and see
how these different smart
contracts actually work together
at the time of filming. rink B
is one of the most popular test
networks along with COVID. So
we're going to work a lot with
Rigby In this tutorial, however,
be absolutely sure to check our
GitHub repository to make sure
that you're always up to date
with the best test network for
following along with the
tutorial here since their test
networks people are running them
out of the goodness of their
hearts. And sometimes the best
ones actually change so, so be
sure to follow along with the
GitHub repository. We might also
use COVID From time to time or
maybe even Grilli. So we're
going to show you how to use a
couple of these different test
nets. In fact, if we go to the
GitHub repo associated with this
course, we can see recommended
test net is indeed currently
ranking. So that's what we're
going to work with should this
change, you should be able to
follow along with another test.
And we'll leave notes as to how
to continue. Now what we can do
actually is we can go to Rigby
ether scan, we can go to,
you can look up Rinku ether
scan, and it looks like it's the
first thing that shows up
Rinkeby dot ether scan.io, we
can punch in this same address,
copy and paste it. And we can
see some of the details of this
address on the Rinkeby ether
scan. Like I said, right now,
it's totally blank. This
networks interface later on is
also how we're going to be able
to work with polygon, avalanche,
etc, we'll just have to add
networks. But we'll get to that
in a bit. And just to reiterate,
test nets are free and for
testing our smart contracts and
main net networks cost money and
are considered live. Now I also
do want to put a caveat here
that we do want to keep in mind
that these test nets are being
run at the goodness of people's
hearts. So we don't want to
abuse them, we want to use them
to learn and then move on. So
try not to send a billion
transactions on one of these
test nets. In fact, what we're
going to do right now is we're
going to send a transaction on
the Rinkeby test net. And this
will show us exactly what it
would look like on a main
network. In order for us to
simulate one of these
transactions, we're going to go
to what's called a faucet. And
if you go to the GitHub
repository associated with this
course, right underneath the
recommended test net is going to
be a test net faucets, which is
going to show us where the most
up to date faucet location is
for us getting test net
Aetherium. So here we are at
faucets dot chain dot link,
which again is the recommended
faucet, and what we can do is we
can actually put our wallet
address in and get some test net
link or test net Aetherium. Now
what we are gonna have to do is
we are gonna have to connect our
wallet to the Rinkeby network.
So we're going to come down,
we're going to switch from COVID
to Etherium. Rigby, and then
we're going to make sure our
meta mask is on the Rinkeby test
network here. Once both of those
are set up, we're gonna go ahead
and hit Connect wallet. And
we're going to choose meta mask.
Once we do that, our meta mask
is actually going to pop up and
say would you like to connect to
this website, connecting to a
website is how we give these
websites in interface to
interact with our wallets and
interact with our meta masks.
Don't worry, we're not sending
any transactions like this,
we'll get to that in a bit. So
we just we can pick an account
we want to connect. Let's choose
our account one, we'll hit Next.
And then we'll go ahead and
connect. Now that we're
connected, we can actually see
our account connected up here.
And that little warning is now
gone. And our wallet address is
automatically placed into here,
we're going to make our first
test transaction. And for now,
we don't need test link. So
we're going to leave that off.
But later on, we're going to
come back and get that test
link. For now we're just going
to need 0.1 test Aetherium.
So let's go ahead and complete
the security by choosing the
traffic lights. And we're going
to hit Send Request. What this
is going to do is we're asking
this faucet to send us 0.1 test
Aetherium test net faucets are
ways for us to get money into
our wallets on a test net. And
this is why this test and
Aetherium isn't worth any actual
money. Since we can get it for
free. These don't exist on Main
net, you can't get real
Aetherium or real money for free
on a main network. So we're on
Rinkeby we're getting fake
Rinckey Aetherium. And we're
gonna go ahead and hit send
request. Once we hit Send
Request, this transaction hash
is going to pop up here, and it
says transactions have been
initiated waiting for
confirmation. This means that
some other wallet is actually
going to send us 0.1 test eath.
And this is the transaction that
it's doing to do that now we
just have to wait for our
transaction to finish verifying
and finish going through. Now if
this doesn't work right away, I
would recommend Wait a minute
and then just try it again. But
what we can do is we can click
this transaction hash. If that
transaction doesn't show up, we
can also just close this. And we
can copy our address here. And
actually we already see 0.1 eath
in our wallets here. But we can
go back over to Rinkeby ether
scan, paste our address and and
we can see that we now have 0.1
ether as a balance. We can also
see that we have a transaction
with all this information going
into our wallet. That's what
this green is for. If you click
that transaction link, you'd get
something like this, but If you
didn't, don't worry, because on
the ether scan, if you click the
transaction hash in the
transaction list, you can also
see all the details like that.
So now in our meta mask, we have
0.1 eath. Again, this is fake
Aetherium. And we have a
transaction associated with our
wallet now, which is awesome.
Again, though, if we switch
networks, if we switch networks
back to Etherium main net, you
can see that we have nothing on
a theory main net. Or if we go
to ropsten, we also have
nothing, we only have this 0.1
eath. On the Rinkeby test
network, if you want to practice
working with another test net,
and the faucet that we're using,
has multiple test nets. Let's go
ahead and try it during this
section right now is completely
optional, you can watch or you
can follow along. But for
example, I can see in my wallet
that we already have COVID
supported, so maybe I'll switch
to COVID. Maybe we'll switch to
COVID. In the drop down here,
we'll remove test 10 Link,
because we only need test eath.
We'll hit I'm not a robot, and
we'll send request and the same
things will pop up this time,
this is going to be for the
COVID test net. And once our
transaction finishes going
through. Now, same thing on
COVID. Here, like what we did
with rink B, once our
transaction finishes going
through, we'll see 0.1 test eath
on the COVID network, if you
want to go ahead and try working
with another one of the test
nets. Like maybe, for example
COVID recommend you go ahead and
giving it a try. But it's
completely optional. And I would
always refer back to the GitHub
repo to make sure you're working
with the most up to date faucet
and test net. And if we look
back at ether scan, we can
actually see more details on
what actually just took place.
What actually just happened, how
did our Metamask get a balance
of 0.1 eath. All of a sudden?
Well, if we looked down in the
transaction section, we can see
that there's a transaction here,
some address sent us 0.1 ether.
And if we click the transaction
hash, we can see more details
about what actually went down
with this transaction. Now
understanding what's going on in
this transaction is essential to
learning and being a smart
contract developer or just
engaging with the ecosystem. So
let's learn the first bit at the
top is this transaction hash.
This is a unique identifier for
this blockchain or this test net
that identifies this exact
transaction. This transaction
hash identifies sending 0.1 eath
to our address, we can see that
the status of this transaction
was successful, it didn't break.
In any case, we can see the
block number that this
transaction was included in and
we'll get to blocks in a little
bit, we can see the timestamp
which of course is when this
transaction occurred, we can see
which account it was from which
if we go ahead and open in a new
tab, we can see that this is the
account that this transaction
came from. And it's got 3
million ether. Of course, this
is fake Rinckey ether. So it
doesn't really matter, we can
all see who it was to, which
again, is just us. This is our
wallet address 0x 106 X blah,
blah, blah, cero x 1066, blah,
blah, blah, right, the value of
this transaction, of course, is
0.1 ether. Now what's all this
that we see as the value so
obviously, the value is 0.1,
because that's a mode which we
sent. But we see this
transaction fee. In this gas
price, we hover over the
tooltip, we can see if you zoom
in on your ether scan, you see
amount paid to the miner for
processing the transaction. And
we see a gas price which is cost
per unit of gas specified for
the transaction and ether and
gray. The higher the gas price,
the higher the chance of getting
included in the block. Now if we
scroll down even more, and we
click See more, we can also see
a ton of other information here.
For now we're just going to
click to see less and just focus
on these two. I'll explain all
of these in a later session.
Let's talk about just
the concept of transaction fees
and gas for a second. Remember
how I said the blockchain is run
by all these different nodes
will all those different nodes
are running this blockchain
because they actually get paid
for all the transactions that
happen on these blockchains
whenever you make a transaction,
there's a node or a miner or or
a validator somebody running the
blockchain software is gonna get
paid a tiny bit of Aetherium or
polygon or whatever blockchain
that you're running on, they're
gonna get paid a tiny bit of
that native blockchain currency.
This payment is obviously to
incentivize people to continue
to run nodes and they calculate
how much you pay and how much
the node operators get paid
based off of how much gas you
use. So there's this concept of
gas. Gas is a unit of
computational measure. The more
computation a transaction uses,
the more gas you'd have to pay
for. For example, we do hit
click More just really quickly.
We can see this section say A
gas limit and gas usage by
transaction, there was a limit
of 60,000 units of gas on this
transaction, and 21,000 or
actually use. So this
transaction use 21 units of gas.
Now for very simple things like
sending ether, the units of gas
are usually pretty cheap. But
maybe for more complex things
like like minting NFT,
depositing to some defy
contract, etc, maybe those will
cost more gas because they'll be
more computationally expensive.
And this is a little confusing
right now, don't worry too much
about it. But just know that we
use 21,000 gas here. And if we
pull out the calculator 21,000
gas times this gas price right
here, times the gas price, we
get the exact same as we see for
the transaction fee. So gas
price, times how much gas you
used, is the transaction fee. So
whoever sent us this 0.1 ether,
also paid 0.0000525, etc Rinkeby
ether to make this transaction.
Now, each blockchain has a
different way of actually
calculating how this gas stuff
works. So that's basically going
to be the high level of it. So
we're going to focus just here
for now there's a total
transaction fee. And then
there's obviously the gas price.
After we cover how blockchain
works, I'll explain what this
burn stuff is these gas fees and
all these other stuff. For now,
just know that anytime you make
a transaction on chain, you have
to pay a little bit of what I
call transaction gas. So for
example, if we go to our
Metamask, we have two accounts
right here, we have account one
was 0.1, Rinckey eath, and
account two was zero. Rigby. If
I were to send 0.05 Rinckey
eath. From this account to my
other account, how much rinky
eath Do you think I'd have left?
Well, let's go ahead and try it,
this will be the first
transaction that you're actually
creating that you are going to
spend the gas for. So if we go
ahead and hit send, we'll hit
transfer between my accounts.
count two, we'll do 0.05.
Next, we can see
some information here about
what's actually going on
Metamask has some new advanced
gas for UI and settings, we're
also going to turn the song, so
go ahead and click that enable
enhanced gas UI, turn that on,
and then go back. And again,
this is going to be the
experimental tab. But it could
also just be in the General
Settings tab. Depending on when
you actually run this, we can
see a little notification here.
Again, this depends on what
version of Metamask we're using.
And we get this little drop down
that says Here are some of the
different type of gas fees that
you can actually pay. The reason
that gas fees might change, as
you can see here is that
depending on how busy the
blockchain is, you have to pay
more gas. If a lot of people are
sending transactions, that means
there's not going to be enough
space for everyone's transaction
to get through. That's a bit of
an oversimplification of what's
happening. But don't worry too
much about it for now. Now, if
we want to send the 0.05 ether
to our second account, we can
see this gas estimated section,
which is saying it's estimating,
we're going to pay 0.00004792
gas in addition to sending the
0.5 eath. So at the bottom, we
have amount plus gas fee. And
this is going to be the total
amount that we're going to be
spending on this transaction
0.05 is what we're sending. And
we also have this gas piece. So
we go ahead and confirm, we now
see we have a transaction
pending in our Rigby ether scan.
And if we click on it, we can
even hit View on block Explorer.
And a Rigby transaction hash
will pop up and depending on
when you click it, it might say
indexing, this means that ether
scan has received your
transaction and is trying to
place it. If you don't see
anything here, it means that
maybe the transaction hasn't
gone through yet. Maybe you need
to wait a little bit more. Or
maybe you need to go back to the
GitHub repo and pick the
recommended testament and
faucet. So you might have to
wait a minute or so for this to
actually finish indexing. After
a minute or so we can see that
this transaction has indeed
passed. And we can see a lot of
the same information that we saw
on our last one, this time with
0.05 ether. And now if we look
in our meta mask, we'll see we
can see account one has 0.05
It's rounding up a little bit,
we click on the big button, we
can see it actually has
0.049953, etc. And our other
account account two does have
exactly 0.05. This is because we
spent a little bit of Aetherium
on gas to send this transaction.
And now with just this little
bit of information, you know how
to actually interact with
applications that use the
blockchain, how to send
transactions and a lot of the
non technical details. Now
here's something that's
incredibly exciting with just
this little bit of information.
You now know how to interact
with blockchains and interact
with the Etherion protocol. So
if you don't want to learn how
to code anything, you can go If
you can start interacting with
Aetherium and interact with
protocols with just as much
information. However, I know
most of you guys are here to
learn how to code. So let's look
under the hood of Aetherium. And
what is actually going on with
these transactions, and what
these gas and what these
blockchains. And what's really
going on, let's learn all the
fundamentals of a blockchain.
Now, if you want to just go
ahead and jump into the coding,
go ahead and grab a timestamp
from the description. However,
learning exactly how the
blockchain works is going to
make you an incredibly powerful
developer.
So let's take a look at that
first. So we're going to
be going through this blockchain
demo on this site right here.
Now, the creator of the site has
a fantastic video and a
fantastic walk through
blockchain one on one, it is
right on their site. So if
you're looking for another
explanation, definitely check
out his video, it is absolutely
fantastic. But the first thing
that we really need to do in
order to understand blockchain
or just on really anything, and
everything that's going on here
working first really need to
understand this Sha 256, hash,
or hashing just kind of in
general, let's first understand
what a hash is. A hash is a
unique fixed length string,
meant to identify any piece of
data, they are created by
putting some piece of data into
a hash function. In this
example, the hashing algorithm
used is Sha 256. Now Etherium
actually uses this, this right
here for its hashing algorithm,
which isn't quite Sha 256, but
as in kind of this SHA family.
But it's really just another way
to hash things. And the specific
hash algorithm doesn't matter so
much. So this example, you just
shot up to six, but you can
imagine it's the same as the
Etherium. Hash, they're just
going to result in a different
hash. So what's going to happen
in this application here is
whatever data or whatever
information we put into this
data section here, as you can
see below this hash changes. So
what's happening is this data is
running through the Sha 256 hash
algorithm. And it's outputting,
this unique hash. So this hash
is a unique fixed length string,
that's going to identify like a
blank data piece here, right. So
if I put in, you know, my name
like Patrick Collins, this is
the hash that's going to
represent Patrick Collins,
right. And you can see, even
when I put, you know, tons and
tons of data in here, the length
of the string doesn't change,
right. So it's always gonna be
the same, we can put almost any
amount of data in here, there is
an upper limit on the max size
of the data. But for all intents
purposes, we can pretty much put
any length in here. And you'll
see to that every time I type in
Patrick Collins, this hash is
always gonna be this seven e
five D, right? I'm gonna delete
I'm gonna do Patrick Collins,
again, you're 75 B is always
this, this unique hash is always
going to be unique, right, it's
always gonna be this fixed
length string here. So now we
can take this idea while putting
this data in here, we can move
on to this concept of a block.
So with this block concept,
we're going to take the exact
same thing with this hash this
this data section, right, but
instead of having everything
just being in this, this
singular data area right here,
we're going to split this data
up into block, nuns, and data.
So all so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to hash
all three of these to get to get
this hash, right, we're gonna
put all three of these, we're
gonna say all three of these are
combined. Together, we're gonna
put every all three of them into
this hashing algorithm to figure
it out. So if I type a bunch of
stuff here, we can see that
block one with nonce, you know,
this nonce, and this data, we're
going to get this hash. And as
you can see, actually, the
screen turns red, this block
turned red. Now, what happens
when I hit this mind button?
When I hit this mind button,
it's actually gonna take some
time, it's gonna think for a
little bit. And we can see that
the nonce here actually changed,
right? The nonce is different
from what it was before. And
this hash now starts with four
zeros. Okay, and then the back
turn green. When we're talking
about mining, we're talking
about miners solving some type
of very difficult problem that
takes a lot of time to do now in
this example, here, the problem
that the miners had to solve was
they had to find a nonce, or or
a value in this nonce section
that when hashed with at block
number one with this data, it
would start with four zeros. So
the problem here the miners had
to solve was to start with four
zeros and the only way for them
to really do that is kind of
this brute force, you know,
trying stuff so they tried one
okay, one didn't work. Okay,
two, nope, two didn't work. 3456
Okay, five, well, that started
with one zero, but it's not
four. And they have to keep
trying all these numbers until
they get to this one where you
know, let's hit mine again.
Where it has four zeros at the
top at the start. Now, this
specific problem changes
blockchain to blockchain right
yet. Aetherium has a different
problem for miners to solve A
bitcoin is different problems
from yourself, but this concept
is going to be the same. So they
have to take it, one block is
going to be this, this, this
concept is going to be all this
data, it's going to be the block
number. And it's going to be
this nonce, right. And so this
nonce is the solution is going
to be the the number that they
use to get like the solution to
the problem, right? So if I go
to one here, you know, I do this
again,
hit mine. And the nonces
changed, right? And went from
one to 33,128. Because this is
the nonce that allowed this hash
to start with four zeros. And so
that's what's happening. When
blockchain miners are mining
they're going through this
process is very computationally
intensive process of trying to
find a nonce that fulfills
whatever the problem is. So
that's really it, actually. So
that's a block. And that's
really what's happening when
miners are mining. They're just
looking, there's trial and
error, brute force trying to
find this nut so so now that we
know what a block is, let's go
to the next step and figure out
okay, well, what's a block
chain. So here we have an
example of what a blockchain is
going to look like. Right, we
have a combination, you know, we
have back here in the block
section, we have one what one
block looks like. Now here, we
have multiple different blocks,
right, each one of these
represents a different block,
but we have an additional column
here, we have additional
variable here. So like before,
you know, we have block nonce
and data, right, we have blocked
nonce data, we also have this
thing called previous right, and
so this is actually gonna be
pointing to the previous hash of
the last block. So for example,
if we go to the last block in
this blockchain, it says
previous 008. And if we look at
the hash of block number four,
is 00008. And then we look at
its previous it's four zeros, B
nine, we have four zeros, B,
nine, and so on, all the way
back to our first block, which
has previous of just all zeros,
right. And so the block with the
previous of all zeros, is going
to be known as the Genesis
block. So you've probably heard
that before the Genesis block,
it's the first block in the
blockchain were the previous
hash points to a hash that
doesn't actually exist. Now, as
you can imagine, kind of the
same as how this block worked,
how the block nuts and dated all
go through the hashing algorithm
in the blockchain, the block
nonce data, and previous hash
all go through this hashing
algorithm to figure out what the
hashes okay? So if we go to over
here, you know, for example, if
I type in Patrick, obviously,
this is now no longer valid,
right? Because this nuns
combined with the block the data
in the previous hash, aren't
going to solve our problem of
having four zeros at the at the
start, right. So I'm gonna go
and fix that. And that's, that's
kind of an easy way to see it
being broken. But, but let's
take a look, if I break this
block, right here, what happens
if I, if I break the data in
here, if I do like Patrick in
here, you can see that both of
these are now read, both of
these are now invalid, right?
Because the block hash with the
nonce hash with the new data,
which is my name, Patrick has
hashed with the previous block
is now a brand new hash, right,
and this block is still pointing
to this previous hash right
here, right is pointing to this
previous block. And now it is
wrong, and it is messed up and
now, and now it's nuts with this
previous hash is also wrong.
Right? And this is where when we
talk about blockchains, being
immutable, this is exactly how
it's immutable, right? Because I
go back and I change anything,
you know, if I've just typed a
right here, the entire
blockchain is now invalidated.
Because none of these are going
to have nonces that solve this
equation anymore. So this is why
blockchains are immutable is
because anytime you change one
thing, you ruin the rest of the
blockchain, okay? So however,
though, you know, if it was
here, originally, we can go
ahead and mine these, mine all
these but as you can see, you
know, this is going to start
getting very computationally
expensive, because I have to go
redo basically the entire
blockchain. And the farther and
farther down the line you get,
the harder and harder it becomes
to, you know, rehash and redo
all these different block chains
here. Now, this makes a lot of
sense, right? So we have this
blockchain, it's really hard to
change something in the past,
but if we do, we can just go
ahead and remind it. Now if I'm
the one who controls the
blockchain, right, if I'm the
one who controls this, you know,
and I want to change something,
the past will, okay, great. All
I got to do is change the state
of here. And then you know,
mine, each one of these, you
know, obviously, it's going to
be very computationally
expensive, but it's something
that I can do right if I'm the
one who owns the blockchain.
Now, here's where the
decentralized nature or the
distributed nature really makes
it incredibly powerful. So we're
gonna go to the distributed tab
here, which is also referred to
as the decentralized tab here,
and it's going to show us what a
blockchain looks like in a
decentralized manner. So we have
this exact same initial setup
here we have to Shoot a
blockchain, we have our first
blockchain, which is kind of
exactly as the one from here.
But we also have more than once
we have peer, a peer beam, and
PRC and when people are talking
about Peer to Peer, peer to peer
transactions through the
talking, this is kind of that
concept that they're talking
about, right. So we have a
number of different peers who
are running this blockchain
technology, they're all weighted
equally, right, each one of
these peers or each one of these
nodes, each one of these
entities running a blockchain
has the exact same power as
anybody else, right. So the way
that we can tell very easily
which blockchain is correct, or
which ones are correct, or by
looking at this end, hash here,
right, or by looking at where we
are in the blockchain, because
again, remember, because again,
remember this, this hash that
this this in this last block
here, is going to encompass all
of the blocks from before,
right, because this last hash is
going to have the previous hash
here, which includes the
previous hash here, which this
hash includes the previous hash
here. And so this last hash is
encompasses everything in here,
right? And we can look, we can
look at the hash of Piercey,
which is four zeros, and then E
four B, we can look at the
latest hash appear B, which is
four zeros, E for B, and then
pure A, which is four zeros, E
for b. So all of these peers,
all of these nodes, all of these
decentralized, you know these
independent, all these
independent users running this
blockchain software, they're all
matched up, it's very easy for
their nodes to look at each
other and say, hey, great, we
are all matched up. Now, what
let's say that a decides that,
you know, something happened on
the blockchain that they didn't
like, and they wanted to go back
and change something, right. So
let's say they change here, you
know, obviously, the rest of
their blockchain is invalidated.
And they have to spend a lot of
computational power to catch up
to speed. So let's go ahead and
humor it. Let's say that they
did, they ended up catching up.
They ended up catching up, you
know, they ended up mining
everything. And now they have a
valid blockchain. Right? It
solves the equation. Awesome.
However, in block number three,
there's something new, right?
This is here, and it shouldn't
have been here, this is some
that Peer A put in by
themselves. All that happens now
is we look at all the
blockchains that are running the
software, and we're looking at
all the hashes and hash at block
number five. So pure A has this
new hash. Now, there's a 09 BC.
But pure B has a different hash
00, e for B, right? So who's
right? Is it disappear a with
their new stuff? Or is it pure
B? Well, that's where the
decentralized data comes in.
Because then we can look at
Piercey Piercey, also as E
forby. So if you're being
Piercey will say, Hey, you're a,
you're wrong, get out, right.
And pure A will stop being able
to participate in the mining
rewards because they have
essentially forked the
blockchain and started their own
little blockchain right with
their own history, because
they're the only ones with this,
this piece of data in block
three, whereas pure B, and pure
C have nothing in there. So that
really shows why in these
blockchain worlds in this
decentralized world, there
really is no centralized entity,
you know, pure A, you know,
might have been maliciously
motivated to change. You know,
there's this block number three,
however, democracy rules, right,
the majority rules in the
blockchain, pure vmpfc will say,
hey, you know, the, that's cute
and all puree. But you're wrong,
right? That's not right. Now, it
might be a little abstract, that
you just look at data and you
know, as typing kind of random
stuff in here and think, okay,
yeah, that's, that's data,
right? That makes sense, you
know, just kind of random
strings in here doesn't really
do anything for us. So if we
actually go over to the token
section here, this is where
everything really starts to make
a lot of sense. So we have the
exact same setup here with pure
a pure B Piercey. Except and the
difference is, instead of having
kind of this, this data section,
we have this TX This transaction
section, right? And this
represents all the transactions
that are happening in this
block, right? So we're sending
$25, from Darcy to Bingle, or to
Bingley force toward dollars and
27 cents here. 1922, right. And
it's the exact same thing. So
this, all these transactions are
gonna get hashed in the exact
same way that the data is going
to get hashed. And, and this is
why it's so powerful, because
again, you know, if I want to be
malicious, right, if, if I want
to say, hey, I really wanted to
give Jane a lot more money from
Elizabeth, so I'm puree and I go
back and I change it to 100.
Well, now, you know not only do
I does my whole blockchain get
invalidated because that was so
so long ago, but I'm not going
to match any of these other
chains. Right? And so my
blockchain is going to be
excluded from the overall
blockchain. So and let's let's
go ahead and fix this. And it's
the same thing if down here if I
become malicious, and I want to
send you know, I want
Miss Audrey to have less money.
Maybe I want to send $1 And they
go had in mind it the same thing
here, this hash now this two a
one is not going to match the
rubies rubies hash of BBA. And
it's not going to match Pierce's
hash of BBA as well. So the two
of them are gonna say, hey,
this, your blockchain is
invalid, it's not matching the
majority, you know, you're out,
right. So that's really how
these blockchains work at a low
level. And it all goes back to
this, this understanding this
hash idea, and using it in this
very sophisticated manner, to
kind of cryptographically prove,
you know, where, where stuff
lies. Now, the way the
blockchain works is, instead of
random stuff, put in the Status
section, it's actually going to
be solidity code in here to
finding ways to interact with
different blocks and different
protocols that are on chain, or,
as we've said before, different
smart contracts. Now, the next
question that you might be
asking is, okay, well, how do I
know how can I be sure that I'm
the one? You know, let's say
this is, let's say, I'm Darcy
right? How can I be sure that I
was that Darcy was the one to
actually send us money here. How
do we know that Darcy sent $25.
To Bingley? Well, this is where
we get into private keys and
public keys. And that's what
we're going to go into. Now.
Let's just do a quick recap of
what we've learned in this
section. So far, right? We've
learned that Aetherium actually
runs on this hit check 256. But
we use Sha 256. For this demo,
it doesn't really matter. We're
just talking about hashing
algorithms. So again, hash is a
unique fixed length string meant
to identify any piece of data. A
hash algorithm or a hash
function is a function or
algorithm that computes any type
of data into a unique hash.
Mining is going to be the
process of finding the solution
to the blockchain problem. In
our example, the problem was
finding a hash that starts with
four zeros. nodes get paid for
mining different blocks. And the
problem is going to be different
blockchain to blockchain a block
and a blockchain is basically a
combination of a block, nonce
transaction and previous hash to
create this unique hash for this
block. And again, depending on
the blockchain implementation,
this might have a couple other
fields or might have different
fields. But this is essentially
what's going on blockchains are
decentralized and distributed
because many independent users
are going to run this blockchain
software. And they will check
and then we'll compare against
each other to see which
blockchains are acting honestly,
and which ones are acting
maliciously, in the blockchain
world majority rules. The nonce
here is the answer used or the
number used to get this hash.
Now nonce is kind of an
overloaded term, it's actually
used for a number of different
reasons. In this case, we're
using it to solve this problem
of getting four or five zeros at
the stop or the hash. However,
in Aetherium, it will also be
often used as the number of
transactions from a given
address.
So now we're going to talk a
little bit about signing these
transactions and private keys
and some other cryptography
pieces, right? Because in this
blockchain demo here, we can see
we have all these these
fantastic transactions, right?
All these things went through,
but how do we know that it was
Darcy? Who was the one to send
$25? To bangli? Right? How do we
know that actually happened. And
this is where all those pieces
that we just learned about in
our test net, in our meta mask
account are really going to
start to, to come to life here a
little bit here. So here we have
an example of public and private
keys, okay, at the top, we have
this private key, right that was
that was randomly generated. A
private key is you know, as it
kind of states is a key that you
really want to keep secret,
because you're going to be using
this as kind of your your secret
password for all your
transactions where I can really
pick, you know, any, any, any
private key, anything that I
want. And with it, this
algorithm, or they're going to
use an algorithm for Aetherium.
Bitcoin, they both use this
elliptic curve, digital
signature algorithm, it's a
variant of just a digital
signature algorithm. And it's
going to create this this public
key, right, I'm really not going
to go at all into kind of this
digital signature algorithm. But
just know it does use some of
these, some of the hash
knowledge that we just learned
combined with some other pieces
to kind of get this this public
here. So I'm not gonna go too
deep into it. But we have this
private key that we create. And
we get this public key. Now this
public key we want everybody to
have access to right this is
yeah, whole world can see this,
this private key, we really want
it to be private, we don't want
people to see this, we're going
to use this private key as like
a password to quote unquote,
digitally sign transactions, and
then people can verify them with
this public key. So let's, let's
see what this actually looks
like. Let's pick a random key, a
more secure key, right? Because
the longer it is, the more
secure it's going to be. And if
we go to signatures now, right?
Let's say we have this, this
message that we want, right?
We'll say hi world, right? We
want this To be the message,
what's gonna happen is this
private key that we've created,
we can use to sign this data,
right? Remember how in the
blockchain demo, you know, we
were kind of we were hashing
stuff, right? We were using this
Shea 256 hash to get this hash.
Well, we're doing something
similar. But instead of hashing,
we're, we're using this digital
signature algorithm to create
this message signature. Now,
what's really powerful about how
this this algorithm works, is
that you can create this message
signature with your private key,
but somebody else can't derive
your private key from the
message signature. And that's
what makes this really, really
powerful. However, if we go to
verify using this public key,
right, and so this is the this
is that, Oh, 403. This is that
same public key, using this,
using this public key, anybody
can verify, let's go ahead and
sign again, anybody can verify
that the signature is yours,
right? So you have a public a
private key, just for you. So
you can sign things and a public
key that anybody can verify
something, right. So anybody can
verify this, and let's say
somebody tries to fake a
transaction from you, they say,
Hey, you know, this is this is
this is their transaction, all
they have to do is verify that
this signature against your
public key and very easily, this
whole thing turns red, because
it isn't verified, right, that
the algorithm says, hey, that's
wrong. So we can go ahead and
take that into transactions in
this exact same way. So if I
want to send money, you know, if
I want to send $400, from, you
know, my address to another
address, using my private key, I
can sign that transaction. And
anybody else in the world can
then verify this transaction,
right. And this is why when
people say Hydra keys, you know,
protect your keys, this is what
we're talking about in our
accounts here. Right? If we go
to settings, and again, the only
reason that I'm showing you
guys, my pneumonic, and my
private key is because this is
a, this is a dumpster account,
I'm going to throw this away at
the end of this video, or I'm
just not gonna put any real
money in it. But when we look at
our Metamask, here, we have this
pneumonic phrase, which allows
us to easily get these different
private keys, right? So
pneumonic phrase combined with,
you know, whatever account
number will get us a private
key. So mnemonic phrase combined
with one, we're gonna get this
private key. And this is when we
look at account details, export
private key.
That's where it confirm, this is
going to be the private key that
we're going to use to sign our
transactions, right, this, if
anybody else gets access to this
private key, they then can sign
transactions for us, and they
can send transactions for us.
And that's why we want to keep
these private, so that it works
the exact same way, right. And
so this is why it's so important
to hide your private keys and
hide your mnemonics now, your
Aetherium address is actually a
piece is actually a piece of
your public key. Now, to get our
address in Aetherium, all we
have to do is take this public
key that we've created with our
private key, hash it using that
same Aetherium hashing
algorithm, and then take the
last 20 bytes. And that's how
we'll actually derive to our to
our address here. Now, knowing
the exact methodology of how to
get the address doesn't really
matter, because it could change
blockchain to blockchain and
could even change it too. But
just know that that is
essentially how kind of these
addresses are derived or there's
some derivative of the public
key, right, because the public
key is public. And you know,
using the public key and kind of
any public way is totally fine,
but not the private key. So that
is how we sign our transactions.
Note though, this isn't how we
send the transaction. So so this
is just going to assign it
create a transaction for us to
send, we'll learn later on how
to send these transactions.
Cool. So that was a lot of
information there too. Let's do
a quick recap, your public key
is derived by using a digital
signature algorithm on your
private key, right, and you want
to keep your private key private
at all times, because you're
going to use your private key to
sign transactions. Signing
transactions with your private
key, you are the only one who
can actually do this because you
can't get the private key from a
message signature. However,
using your public key, you can
anybody can very easily verify
that a signature that signed by
you is in fact signed by you in
our meta mask. Our private keys
are located in this account
details section you just hit
show private keys and type in
your password. And you'll get
your your private key here. A
quick note here is oftentimes
when using your private keys
somewhere, they want it in
hexadecimal form. So if we're
going to use our private key for
something like brownie, which
we'll go into later, we need to
actually append a 0x to the
front but We'll get into that
later. And the address of your
account is derived from this. So
if you think about your private
key creates your public key,
which then can create your
address. And there's a little
barrier or a big barrier here.
Because your private key, you
want to keep private and your
public key and your address can
all be public information.
Now that we know a little
bit more about what's going on
underneath the hood of these
blockchains, let's go back at
our transactions and look at
this gas thing again, and we'll
look to see what's actually
happening here, gas in
particular can be a little bit
tricky to wrap your head around.
So if you don't get it right
away, don't worry. As we go
through examples, it'll start to
make more sense. So before I was
saying, let's just look at this
transaction fee bid, which is
the costs associated with
running this transaction. If I
scroll over this on ether scan,
I can see this thing that says
block base fee per gas plus max
party fee per gas times the gas
use, which might be a little bit
confusing here, let's actually
break down what's going on on
Aetherium with ERP 15, five nine
in place. And again, this is
going to be specific to
Aetherium, as every blockchain
might do it a little bit
differently. But if we click to
see more, we can see a number of
useful values here, we can see
gas limit is 21,000. And usage
is 21,000. So this transaction
used 21,000 gas, and we sent
21,000 gas along with it.
Sometimes when sending a
transaction, depending on when
it's sent. And depending on what
the specific instructions are,
it might actually use way more
gas than what you want it to
use. So with your transactions,
you can actually set a limit,
hey, I don't want to use more
than x amount of gas, I don't
want to do more than x
computational units. And in
fact, we go to our Metamask. And
we click Send to transfer
between accounts again, and we
pick you know, 0.01 eath, or
something next can actually hit
this little button here, go to
Advanced, and we can actually
edit some specifics of this
transaction, one of them is
going to be the gas limit, we
can change this gas limit to
maybe 2200 2300, or more or even
less, since sending Aetherium
takes exactly 21,000 Gas
Metamask just defaults to
setting into that. Well, we also
see these other interesting
things, we see a priority fee,
and a max base fee. Let's reject
this transaction. And let's look
back at ether scan to talk about
these. So currently in
Aetherium, according to EE IP
1559, every transaction on
Aetherium comes with something
called the base fee. This is the
minimum gas price you need to
set to include your transaction.
And you'll notice that these are
priced in something called
gateway. So what is a gateway?
If we come to the site eath
converter.com. And again,
there's a link to this in the
GitHub repository, we scroll
down we can see way gateway and
ether five put one ether in
here, I can see how much one
ether is in terms of way. And in
terms of way, one ether is equal
to 1-234-567-8990. So that's
that's 1 billion way is going to
be one ether. And then
1-234-567-8910 1112 1314 Did 16
Seven, eight team and then 18
zeros is away. These are just
easier ways of referring to
really, really small amounts of
Aetherium. So if we look at our
gas fees, we see that the base
fee is 0.00000004 Go away. And
this obviously would be an even
smaller number if this was in
units of weigh. So if we take
this number, and we put it into
our calculator, we can see that
this is equal to 40 weigh or
0.0000 a whole bunch of zeros
for ether. The max fee here
refers to the maximum gas fee
that we're willing to pay for
this transaction. And you can
actually see that our max fee is
a little bit higher than what we
actually ended up paying. Our
maximum was 2.2132 something
something and the gas price we
actually paid was up here. Now
your transaction might of course
be a little bit different than
Additionally we have a max
priority fee. This is going to
be the max gas fee that we're
willing to pay plus the max tip
that we're willing to give to
miners. Now currently in
Aetherium, this base fee ends up
getting burnt and we can see on
ether scan exactly how much is
getting burnt here. And if we
pull up our calculator again, we
can grab this gas fee, multiply
it by the amount of gas we used,
and we can see that this is
indeed how much Aetherium we
actually ended up burning. We go
back to Ethereum converter,
paste it in we can see that
these two numbers are indeed
equal. This means whenever you
send a transaction, a little bit
of Aetherium is removed from
circulation forever, or it's
considered burnt. So currently,
in theory As part of your
Aetherium part of your
transaction fee actually gets
burnt. And then the other part
goes directly to miners. So to
figure out exactly how much went
to miners, we could do this
number minus the burnt amount.
And this is how much Etherium
was paid to Aetherium miner for
this transaction, you'll see
down here your transaction type
to ERP 15, five, nine, this is
the eip 15 five nine version of
these transactions. Like I said,
every blockchain is going to
have a different fee burning and
fee and gas process. And they're
all going to be a little bit
different, but the some of it is
blockchains have limited block
space for transactions, the gas
price that costs for your
transaction to be included in
one of these blocks changes
based off how much demand there
is the base gas fee for
Aetherium will go up and down
depending on how many people are
sending transactions and how
many people want to be included
in a block. If a ton of people
want to be included in a block.
That means a ton of gas is
obviously going to get burnt.
We've left a link to a video in
the GitHub repository with this
section from this YouTuber who
does an amazing job breaking
down this EIP 15, five, nine and
more about how this gas model
actually works. I highly
recommend you pause this video
and watch that video. To
understand more, the base fee
gets programmatically
algorithmically adjusted to try
to target for all the blocks to
be 50% full. If they're more
than 50% full, this base fee
automatically goes up. If
they're less than 50% full, this
base fee goes down. Now this is
a lot of the basics of how this
transaction works. And it can be
a little confusing. So let's do
a quick refresher of everything
in here. There's a unique
transaction hash that uniquely
identifies this transaction. On
this blockchain, we can see the
status, we can see the block
number that it's confirmed on.
One other thing we want to look
at. If we scroll up, we see
block number and block
confirmations. This is how many
blocks have been mined. Since
this block was included. Like we
saw with our blockchain demo,
the longer the blockchain gets,
the harder it is to tamper with
and the more secure it is
typically, you'll see some
processes say they'll only do
something after 20 Block
confirmations, 30 Block
confirmations or etc. The reason
that they wait for these block
confirmations is because they
want to make sure that that
transaction is actually
included. And we can actually
see the block that our
transaction was included in and
all the other transactions with
it, different details about how
much gas was used, the gas
limit, etc. timestamp is when
the transaction happened, we can
see from and to we can see the
value. And then we can see the
transaction fee, which we see
right here is blocked base fee
per gas plus the max priority
fee per gas times the gas used.
And we see all the details of
the gas down here gas price is
the cost of one unit of gas gas
limit is the max amount of units
of gas that we're willing to pay
in this transaction, the usage
is how many actually got us the
base fee is going to be the base
network fee per gas. So 40 way
per one gas used, the max gas is
the max gas price we're willing
to pay. And Max priority is
gonna be the max gas price, plus
the tip that we give to miners,
and then we can see how much is
burnt. And then we see
transaction savings which which
is the difference between how
much was actually used or paid
for and then returned. So for
example, in this transaction,
the gas price we ended up
picking was a little less than
our max gas price here. So the
gas price we ended up using was
a little less than our max
priority fee here. So we had
some savings compared to that,
we can also see that this was an
ERP 15 five nine transaction, we
can see our nonce here, which
was not zero because the
transaction that I'm showing is
our first nones. And then of
course, we can see the input
data for transactions that are
just sending Aetherium, the
input data is going to be blank.
But you'll see that when we get
to smart contracts, the input
data is not going to be blank.
And it's going to be one of the
most important features of these
transactions. You'll also notice
that there's a state tab. This
is an advanced tab, and it shows
the different states that are
changed based off of this
transaction. We're going to
ignore this one for now. Now
that we know how the blockchain
itself works under the hood,
let's talk about some blockchain
fundamentals. And we actually
covered all these topics in a
previous Freako camp video. So
let's go to that.
If the first time
you listen to this, some of
these concepts seem a little bit
hard to grasp. Don't worry about
it. As we continue and as we
move on with this course,
they'll start to make more sense
when you see them used in real
examples. I definitely would
recommend going back and
rewatching and re listening to
the parts that you don't quite
get an asking questions in the
discussions tab of the GitHub
repository. Awesome. So now that
we know all the cryptography
pieces and all the little nitty
gritties of how the blockchain
actually works, and how our
signatures work and how
everything sticks together.
Let's talk a little bit about
how this works, in actuality,
and what's really going on. Now
for a lot of this, each
different blockchain has
slightly different algorithms
and slightly different metrics
and criteria for doing a lot of
this stuff. So when we're
talking about these specific
implementations, keep in mind,
the exact algorithm might be a
little bit different, but the
concepts are all still going to
be exactly the same. Hashing and
hash function is going to be the
same. No matter where you look
at decentralized blockchain,
it's going to be the same no
matter where you look, how it's
actually implemented, is going
to be a little bit different.
Now traditionally, when you run
an application, you will be
website or something that
connects to some server, you are
interacting with a centralized
entity. And unlike how we saw
with the blockchain with
multiple different peers, it's
going to be run by a single
centralized group. Now, it still
could be run on many different
servers, but all those servers
are still going to be controlled
by the same centralized group
blockchains, as we saw run on a
network of different independent
nodes. When we saw a peer, a
peer, B Piercey. Those were
different examples of different
independent users running the
blockchain technology on their
own node. Now, when I use the
term node, I'm usually referring
to a single instance of a
decentralized system. So when I
say a single node, when I'm
talking about a blockchain, I'm
talking about one of those pure
A's pure BS pure C's running
that blockchain software, I'm
talking about one server running
this technology. And again, it's
this network. It's this
combination of these nodes
interacting with each other,
that creates this entire
blockchain. What makes these so
potent too, is that anybody can
join the network. And that's why
there's decentralized the
barrier to entry is a little bit
of hardware requirements for
getting the correct materials to
run the software. And then you
running the software, anybody
can join these networks and
participate. And that's what
makes it truly decentralized. In
fact, you can go to GitHub right
now, and run your own Aetherium
node in a few seconds. Now in
the traditional world,
applications are run by
centralized entities. And if
that entity goes down, or is
maliciously bribed, or decides
that they want to shut off, they
just can't, because they are the
ones that control everything.
blockchains, by contrast, don't
have this problem. If one node
or one entity that runs several
nodes goes down, since there are
so many other independent nodes
running that it doesn't matter,
the blockchain and the system
will persist so long as there is
at least one node always
running. And luckily for us,
most of the most popular chains
like Bitcoin and Aetherium, have
1000s and 1000s of nodes. And as
we showed in our demo, if one
node acts maliciously, all the
other nodes will ignore that
node and kick that out or even
punish it in some systems,
because they can easily check
everybody else's node and see,
okay, this one is out of sync
with the majority. And yes,
majority rules when it comes to
the blockchain. Each blockchain
keeps a full list of every
transaction and interaction
that's happened on that
blockchain and we saw if a node
tries to act maliciously, then
all their hashes are going to be
way out of whack and they're not
going to match everybody else.
This gives blockchains this
incredibly potent immutability
trait where nothing can be
changed or corrupted. So in
essence, we can think of a
blockchain as a decentralized
database. And with Aetherium, it
has an extra additional feature
where it also can do computation
in a decentralized manner. Now
let's talk consensus, proof of
work and proof of stake because
you've probably heard these
before. And they're really
important to how these
blockchains actually work. We
went through that blockchain
example, and we did that mining
feature. This is what's known as
proof of work. Proof of Work and
proof of steak fall under this
umbrella of consensus and
consensus is a really important
topic when it comes to
blockchains. Consensus is
defined as the mechanism used to
reach an agreement on the state
or a single value on the
blockchain, especially in a
decentralized system. I briefly
alluded to this consensus
mechanism in our blockchain
example, when I said if one
change is something and the
other two, don't, then majority
will rule and kick that one out.
This is part of that consensus
mechanism. Now very roughly a
consensus protocol in a
blockchain or decentralized
system can be broken down into
two pieces, a chain selection
algorithm, and a civil
resistance mechanism, that
mining piece that we were doing,
or where the proof of work
algorithm is what's known as a
civil resistance mechanism. And
this is what Aetherium and
Bitcoin currently use. Please
note that depending on when
you're watching this, if eath
two is out, then it's no longer
proof of work. Now, proof of
work is known as a civil
resistance mechanism, because it
defines a way to figure out who
is the block author, which node
is going to be the node who did
the work to find that mine and
be the author of that block so
all the other nodes can verify
that it's accurate civil
resistance is a blockchains
ability to defend against users
creating a large number of
pseudo anonymous identities to
gain a disproportionately
advantageous influence is over
set system. And in layman's
terms, it's basically a way for
a blockchain to defend against
somebody making a bunch of fake
blockchains so that they can get
more and more rewards. Now,
there are two types of civil
resistance mechanisms that we're
going to talk about here. Namely
proof of work and proof of
stake. Let's talk about proof of
work a little bit more in depth
first, in proof of work. This is
civil resistant, because a
single node has to go through a
very computationally expensive
process called mining, which we
demonstrated earlier to figure
out the answer to the
blockchains Riddle of finding
that correct nonce, or, or
whatever the
blockchain system has in place.
And proof of work. This works
because no matter how many
pseudo anonymous accounts you
make, each one still has to
undergo this very
computationally expensive
activity of finding the answer
to the proof of work problem, or
the proof of work riddle, which
again, in our demonstration, it
was finding a nonce with that
first four zeros. But again,
each blockchain might change the
riddle work or change the
problem to be a little bit
different. In fact, some of
these blockchains make this
riddle intentionally hard or
intentionally easy to change
what's called the block time,
the block time is how long it
takes between blocks being
published. And it's proportional
to how hard these algorithms
are. So these problems actually
can change. Depending on how
long they want the blockchain to
be. If a system wants to block
time to be very, very long, they
just make the problem very, very
hard. If they wanted to be very
short, they make the problem a
lot easier. We'll talk about
civil attacks in a little bit
and how they can affect the
system. But with proof of work,
it's a verifiable way to figure
out who the block author is and
be civil resistant. Now, you
need to combine this with a
chain selection rule create this
consensus. Now, there's some
consensus protocols that have
more features, but very, very
roughly, these are the two
pieces that we're going to look
at. The second piece is going to
be a chain selection rule. How
do we know which blockchain is
actually the real blockchain and
the true blockchain now on
Bitcoin and Aetherium, they both
use a form of consensus called
Nakamoto consensus. And this is
a combination of proof of work
and longest chain rule, the
decentralized network side that
whichever blockchain has the
longest chain, or the most
number of blocks on it is going
to be the chain that they use.
This makes a lot of sense,
because every additional block
that a chain is behind, it's
going to take more and more
computation for it to come up.
That's why when we saw in our
transaction, we actually saw
confirmations. The number of
confirmations is the number of
additional blocks added on after
our transaction went through in
a block. So if we see
confirmations as to it means
that the block that our
transaction was in has two
blocks ahead of it in the
longest chain. Now, I do want to
point out that a lot of people
use proof of work as a consensus
protocol. And I do want to say
that this is a little bit
inaccurate, but sometimes people
use it interchangeably. Proof of
Work is a piece of the overall
consensus protocol, which in
Bitcoin and Aetherium. One
current case is Nakamoto
consensus, Nakamoto consensus is
a combination of proof of work,
and this longest chain rule,
both equally and very, very
important. Now, proof of work
also tells us where these
transaction fees and these block
rewards go to remember how when
we made this transaction, we had
to talk about gas and a
transaction fee. So who's
getting paid who was getting
this transaction, and this
transaction fee is going to the
miners or the validators in a
proof of work network? They're
called miners and in the proof
of stake network, they're called
validators there are a little
bit different. And we'll get
into that when we talk about
proof of stake in this proof of
work system. All these nodes are
competing against each other to
find the answer to the
blockchain riddle. Remember, in
our example, it was to find a
hash that has four zeros at the
start. And again, depending on
the blockchain implementation,
that riddle is going to be a
little bit different. But all
the nodes are trying as many as
possible to try to get this
answer first. Why? Because the
first node to figure out the
answer to the blockchain real is
gonna get that transaction fee,
they're gonna get paid from
that. Now, when a node gets
paid, they actually get paid in
two different ways. One is going
to be with a transaction fee.
And another piece is going to be
the block reward. Remember how
we talked about alternating the
gas price or the gray on our
transaction? Well, that's the
transaction fee that we're going
to pay to these blockchain nodes
for including our transaction,
the block reward is given to
these nodes from the protocol
from the blockchain itself.
You've probably heard of the
Bitcoin halving before the
halving is referring to this
block reward getting cut in half
and it's supposed to be cut in
half, roughly every four years.
This block reward increases the
circulating amount of whatever
cryptocurrency that is being
rewarded. For example, on
Aetherium the block reward is
giving out Aetherium and a
Bitcoin the block reward is
giving out Bitcoin. So these
nodes are competing against each
other to be the first one to
find this transaction to be the
first one to find the answer to
this problem, so that they can
be the ones to win both this
block reward and your
transaction fee. Some block
chains like Bitcoin, for
example, have a set time when
they're no longer going to give
out block rewards and the miners
or the nodes are only going to
get paid from trends. Action
fees. Now this gas fee, again is
paid by whoever initialize the
transaction. When we got our
funds from the faucet, there was
some server and somebody else
was paying the transaction fee
for us. However, when we sent
ether from one account to
another, our first account
actually paid some transaction
fee to send that ether. In proof
of steak. There's also a gas
fee, but it's paid out to
validators instead of miners.
And we'll talk about that in a
little bit. Now let's talk about
two types of attacks that can
happen in these blockchain
worlds. Let's talk about the
first one being the Sybil
attack. The Sybil attack is when
a user creates a whole bunch of
pseudo anonymous accounts to try
to influence a network. Now,
obviously, on Bitcoin and
Aetherium, this is really,
really difficult because user
needs to do all this work in
proof of work or have a ton of
collateral and proof of stake,
which again, we'll talk about in
a bit. The other more prevalent
attack is what's known as a 51%
attack. Now, as we saw as part
of our consensus protocol, these
block chains are going to agree
that the longest chain is the
one that they're going to go
with, so long as it matches up
with 51% of the rest of the
network. This means that if you
have the longest chain, and you
have more than 51% of the rest
of the network, you can do
what's called a fork in the
network, and bring the network
onto your now longest chain. Now
Sybil attacks, obviously, are
when a single node or a single
entity tries to affect the
decent reality of the network by
pretending to be multiple
different people, although
they're just the same person or
entity. And like I said, it's
really difficult to do in proof
of work and proof of steak. So
you can see now that blockchains
are very democratic, whichever
blockchain has the most buy in
and is the longest is the
blockchain that the whole system
is going to corroborate. When
nodes produce a new block and
add to the longest chain, the
other nodes will follow this
longest chain that the rest of
the network is agreeing with,
add those blocks to their chain
and follow up. So very small
reorganizations are actually
pretty common when a blockchain
picks a block from a different
longest chain puts it on and
then has to swap it out for
another block and continue with
a different blockchain. However,
if a group of nodes had enough
nodes or enough power, they
could essentially be 51% of the
network and influence the
network in whatever direction
that they want it. This is
what's known as a 51% attack.
And it's happened on blockchains
like Ethereum classic, which is
not Aetherium. This is why the
bigger a blockchain is, the more
decentralized and the more
secure it becomes.
So after you watch this video,
and you become a blockchain
engineering expert, I definitely
recommend you run a node as
well, because you are going to
increase the security of the
network as a whole by running a
node. So proof of work is
fantastic because it allows us
to very easily protect against
the Sybil attacks and keep our
blockchain is decentralized and
secure. However, it has some
drawbacks as well. Proof of Work
costs a lot of electricity,
because every single node is
running as fast as they can to
win this race to get the
rewards. This leads to obviously
an environmental impact. Now
since proof of work and Nakamoto
consensus, a lot of other
protocols have taken this idea
and gone in a different
direction with a different civil
resistance protocol, a lot of
them with the intention to be a
lot more environmentally
friendly. And the most popular
one right now is proof of stake.
There are some chains that are
already using this proof of
stake protocol, and that are
live and thriving. Some of them
are like avalanche, LaLana,
Polygon, polka dot and Terra and
additionally Aetherium is
decided to upgrade to eath. Two,
which will have this proof of
stake algorithm as well, it will
also have some other features,
which we'll talk about in a bit.
Now as a quick aside, all the
tools that we're going to learn
here are still going to work in
eath. Two, so depending on when
you watch this, everything here
is still valid. So let's talk
about proof of stake. Now,
again, this is a different civil
resistance mechanism. Instead of
solving this difficult problem,
proof of stake nodes put up some
collateral that they're going to
behave honestly, aka, they stake
in the example of Aetherium. two
nodes put up some Aetherium as a
stake that they're going to
behave honestly in the network,
if they misbehave to the
network, they are going to be
slashed or remove some of their
steak. Obviously, this is a very
good civil resistance mechanism.
Because if you try to create a
whole bunch of anonymous
accounts, then each one of those
accounts, you have to put up
some stake. And if you
misbehave, you're going to run
the risk of losing all the money
that you put up as collateral.
In this system, miners are
actually called validators
because they're no longer
binding anything, they're
actually just validating other
nodes. Now, unlike proof of
work, which every node is racing
to be the first one to find the
block, and proof of stake nodes
are actually randomly chosen to
propose the new block and then
the rest of the validators will
validate if that node has
proposed the block. Honestly, as
we saw with our cryptography
lesson, it's usually very easy
for other nodes to verify if a
proposal or a transaction is
honest. Now randomness is a
really important topic when
we're talking about blockchains.
Because keep in mind, these
blockchains are deterministic
systems. They're walled gardens
from the rest of the world. And
as you know, a deterministic
system by definition can't have
random numbers. So how do we
choose the random validators in
the system? While it changes
from blockchain to blockchain,
and actually choosing the node
will change blockchain to
blockchain, but eath two,
they're using what's called Rand
doubt, at least for the original
implementation. This is a
decentralized autonomous
organization that collectively
chooses the random number and
collectively chooses which node
is going to run. Next, we aren't
going to dive too deep into this
because there's a good chance
that this might change in the
future. But we will go into
randomness solutions and
blockchain later on in this
course. Now, proof of stake
obviously has some pros and cons
as well, pros are that again, it
is a great civil resistance
mechanism. And a great way to
figure out who the author of a
block should be. The other pros
are that it's way less
computationally expensive to
figure out the new block,
because instead of every single
node on the network trying to do
this, only one node needs to do
this. And then the rest of the
nodes just need to validate it.
The cons are that it's usually
considered a slightly less
decentralized network, due to
the upfront staking costs it
cost to participate. Now, this
gets into a little bit of a
philosophical battle on how
decentralized is decentralized
enough. And I think that's up to
the community to decide. And as
we progress, I think we'll learn
more and more about how
decentralized is decentralized
enough. The general consensus
amongst blockchain engineers,
though, is that proof of stake
is very, very decentralized and
very secure. This massive
environmental impact improvement
is one of the two main reasons
why eath is shifting to eath.
Two, it reduces the
environmental impact by up to
99%. Now, these are the main
pieces of proof of work and
proof of stake. But I did want
to talk about another concept
that's really important in these
ecosystems. And that is
scalability. When we were
talking about gas prices, we
were saying that the gas prices
can get really high if a lot of
people want to send a
transaction, because a block
only has so much black space,
and the nodes can only add so
many notes. So when a lot of
people want to use a blockchain,
the gas price skyrockets. This
is not very scalable, because if
we want to add more and more
people to these blockchains,
it's going to cost more and more
to use the blockchains. Because
more people are going to want to
get into these blocks. This
means that there's kind of a
ceiling to how many people can
use the system because of the
financial constraints that will
get imposed as gas prices keep
rising. Aetherium too is not
only attacking the environmental
impact of proof of work by
switching to proof of steak, but
they're also implementing this
new methodology called sharding.
And sharding is a solution to
the scalability problem, a
sharded blockchain really just
means that it's going to be a
blockchain of blockchains
there's a main chain that's
going to coordinate everything
amongst several chains that hook
into this main chain. This means
that there's more chains for
people to make transactions on
effectively increasing the
amount of block space that there
is sharding can greatly increase
the number of transactions on a
blockchain layer one now there's
another term that might be the
first time you heard it, a layer
one, we're going to talk about
layer one and layer twos in
terms of scalability really
quickly as well. A layer one
refers to any base layer
blockchain implementation
Bitcoins, a layer one Aetherium
the layer one avalanches, a
layer one, these are the base
layer blockchain solutions. A
layer two is any application
that is added on top of a layer
one added on top of the
blockchain. Some examples of
layer twos are going to be chain
link arbitrage, or optimism.
Arbitrage and optimism are very
interesting because they are
layer twos that also look to
solve this scalability issue.
Arbitrage and optimism are
what's known as roll ups and
they roll up their transactions
into a layer one like Aetherium,
we're not going to go too deep
into roll ups and how they
actually work. But all you
really need to know is that a
roll up is kind of like a
sharded chain, they derive their
security from the base layer
from the layer one like
Aetherium. And they bulk send
their transactions onto the
layer one, they solve some of
the scalability issues by being
another blockchain that people
can make transactions on, still
on kind of this base Aetherium
layer. Now they're different
from side chains. Because side
chains derive their security
from their own protocols, roll
ups, derive their security from
the base layers. So arbitrage
and optimism, for example, is
going to be just about as secure
as Aetherium. There's some
fantastic guys in there that go
a little bit deeper into roll
ups and I've left a link in the
description for you. All right,
so we just talked about a lot of
stuff. So let's do a quick recap
before moving on. Aetherium and
Bitcoin are currently both proof
of work blockchains that follow
Nakamoto consensus, however,
Aetherium is moving to Aetherium
two, which will be a proof of
stake sharded blockchain Sybil
attacks are prevented due to
protocols like proof of work and
proof of steak 51% attacks grow
increasingly harder with the
size of blockchain. So you
should run a node consensus is
the mechanism that allows a
blockchain to agree upon what
the state of the blockchain is
sharding and roll ups are
solutions to scalability issues
on layer ones. Layer One is any
based blockchain implementation
like Bitcoin or Aetherium. A
blockchain scalability problem
is that there's not always
enough block space for the
amount of transactions that want
to get in them. This leads to
very high gas prices and a
Again, gas prices or how much it
costs to interact with the
blockchain.
So that's it for the blockchain
basics and the blockchain
explainers. With just this
information, you now can go off
into the world and start working
with blockchains and interacting
with blockchains. With at least
some level of knowledge as to
what's going on, you should be
incredibly proud of yourself for
just making it this far.
Definitely be sure to give
yourself a pat on the back and a
round of applause. Now that
we've gotten a lot of the basics
and the fundamentals of the way,
let's start jumping into the
coding aspect. This is where
you're going to learn how to
actually build these smart
contracts, how to build these
trust minimized agreements, in
these blockchains. And in the
smart contract platforms. This
next section, this solidity
basics, the solidity
fundamentals section will give
you all the skills to start
actually coding solidity and
understanding how these smart
contracts work underneath the
hood. So at this point,
absolutely, give yourself a high
five, maybe say hi, in the
GitHub discussions, maybe say hi
in the community, on Twitter, on
Reddit, etc, and be proud of
just making it this far, the
journey has really only just
begun, but you've already
learned so much. Let's begin the
next section. And let's
jump into the code.
Now that we're getting to the
coding sections, I need to
stress to absolutely use the
GitHub repository associated
with this course. If you come to
the GitHub repo, and you scroll
down, and you click the lesson
that we're on right now, we're
on lesson two. Welcome to remix,
simple storage. If you click on
it, it'll give you a ton of
timestamps and, and other
helpful links associated with
this lesson. Additionally, the
biggest piece is that all the
code will be available right
underneath the lesson title.
This will have all the code that
we're going to be working with,
as well as some more additional
information on how to work with
the code. Please, when asking
questions and entering in
discussions, though, please ask
your questions and the full
blockchain solidity course
repository. Thank you. And if
we're at the top of the
repository, and we scroll down,
we have the resources for this
course section. Which brings us
to the GitHub discussions in
which you can ask questions in
the GitHub discussion section of
this course. Additionally, on
Stack Exchange, Aetherium, or at
Stack Overflow. I'll talk a
little bit about how to format
questions and ask questions the
best way so that you have the
highest chance of getting a good
answer in a later lesson, I
highly recommend you pause and
make accounts for Stack Exchange
Aetherium, Stack Overflow, and
GitHub right now, if you haven't
already, links to them, of
course, can be found in our
GitHub repository. Typically,
for each coding section, I'll
start it off by giving a quick
overview of the code of what
we're going to be working with
and what we're going to be
building towards, since
everything that we're doing is
going to be project based. And
that's how we're going to learn.
For our first one and remix
though, we're going to skip over
that because there's a lot of
stuff to get used to. Now, I
highly recommend that as I'm
coding this. And as I'm doing
all this in remix, you follow
along with me and you code along
with me. Remember, you can
change my speed if I'm coding
too fast, or if I'm coding too
slow. To start, we're going to
jump into a tool called remix.
If you're unsure how to get
there, there's a link to remix
in our GitHub repository. This
is where we're gonna be writing
all of our code. So welcome to
the remix IDE, or integrated
development environment. This is
where we're going to learn how
to code and interact with our
smart contracts. If you want,
you can go ahead and accept help
out remix. If you've never been
here before, it'll give you a
quick walkthrough of some of the
tools that remix actually has,
we're going to skip over them
for now. Because I'm gonna
explain everything that's going
up. Remix is such a powerful
tool because it has a lot of
features that allow us to really
see and interact with our smart
contracts. Eventually, we're
going to move off of remix,
actually to a local development
environment. However, remix is
absolutely fantastic for
learning the fundamentals of
solidity. And I highly recommend
everybody start with remix when
they're getting started. When
you come to the remix IDE,
there's a whole lot of different
things that are popping out to
us. There's a lot of different
plugins as well. Since we're
going to be working with
solidity, which is going to be
the language that we're using to
develop our smart contracts. We
can go ahead and get started by
clicking the solidity plugin,
and a couple of other tools will
show up on the side. Even if you
don't click the solidity plugin,
you'll still be able to code
solidity smart contracts, the
left hand side is where we're
going to start to actually
interact with things. The button
on the top most of the left is
our files or explore
directories, remix comes
boilerplate with some different
contracts, some different
scripts, some different tests,
and different dependencies. We
are going to minimize this a
little bit. So if you want to go
ahead and right click and delete
some of these folders other than
the contracts folders, feel free
to do so. Or if you kind of like
them there, feel free to leave
them as well. We're going to
leave our contracts folder and
we're going to delete the
different files inside of it
just so that we can start From a
blank slate. Most projects come
with something known as a
readme. Usually it's a
readme.md, which usually
explains how to actually work
with code. But for our purposes,
we're going to delete this as
well. And you can just follow
along with
me. Now we have a blank
remix Setup, click on the
contracts folder and click the
little page icon to create a new
file, a little box will pop up
and you can start typing text
into it. We're going to type in
simple storage dot Sol, dot Sol
tells our compilers that this is
going to be a solidity file, and
that we're going to code
solidity in this solidity is the
primary coding language of smart
contracts. There are a few other
smart contract languages as
well. But solidity by far is the
most dominant smart contract
coding language out there. And
now we have a simple storage dot
soul contract on the right that
we can actually start coding our
solidity with. So let's start
coding some solidity. Now if you
click on this button right below
the files button that looks like
the solidity logo, you'll see a
bunch of stuff pop up in here.
These are different parameters
for us to actually compile our
solidity code so that we can run
it. So the first thing that
you're going to need in any
solidity smart contract is going
to be the version of solidity
that you're going to use. And
this should always be at the top
of your solidity code, solidity
is a constantly changing
language, and it constantly
updating language. Because it's
relatively new compared to other
languages, we need to tell our
code, hey, this is the version
that I want you to use, we can
add the solidity version by
doing pragma. solidity. And then
the version that we want to use,
if we want to choose a very
specific version, we could say
zero, point 8.7. The most
current version to date is 0.8.
Point 12. But getting used to
different versions of solidity
is good practice, and different
versions of solidity are
considered more stable than
others. Zero point 8.7 is one of
those versions that is
considered more stable. These
double slashes here are what's
known as a comment, there are
places where you can type stuff
that won't actually get executed
in won't get compiled and isn't
really considered part of your
code. For example, I could write
Hello all. I'm Patrick. And if
we were going to run this code,
this part of my code would get
completely ignored. So this
double backslash is how we do
what's called comments. And as
we're coding, and as we're
building our projects, be sure
to use this comments tool to
your advantage every time you
write a new function, or you
learn something that you didn't
understand, or you learned
something new that you want to
remember, put it in a comment in
your code, you're going to be
most effective at taking notes
in this course, by making them
comments in your code and then
saving your code so you can
refer back to it later. So leave
comments in your code, leave
notes in your code. And that
will be one of the best ways for
you to understand what you're
coding when you want to refer
back to it later. Now when it
comes to the versions of
solidity, there's actually a few
different ways we can actually
write it, we can say we want to
use only zero point 8.7. And
this is how we would write that.
But maybe we're okay if we use a
more new version of solidity
than zero point 8.7 to tell our
code that we're okay with a more
new version, we can put a little
caret here. And this is how we
tell solidity. Hey, any version
of zero point 8.7 And above is
okay for this contract. This
means zero point 8.8 would work
zero point 8.9 0.8 point 10,
etc. But if we wanted to use
just 0.17, we would type in like
that if we want to use solidity
versions between a specific
range, we could do something
like this, we can say we want
our solidity version greater
than or equal to zero point 8.7
But less than zero point 9.0.
This means that any compiler
between zero point 8.7 and zero
point 9.0 would work. This means
zero point 8.8 would work. Zero
point 8.9 would work 0.8 point
10 would work. But zero point
9.0 would not work because it is
not strictly less than 0.9 point
00 point 9.1 would also not
work. To keep things simple for
us, we're going to use zero
point 8.8. And every line of
solidity that's completed, every
completed section needs to end
with one of these semicolons
this is how you tell solidity
it's the end of the line. Also
at the top of your code, you're
always going to want to put
what's called an spdx license
identifier. This is optional,
but some compilers will flag
your warning that you don't have
one. This is to make licensing
and sharing code a lot easier.
We have a link to more about how
licenses work in the section of
this lesson in our GitHub
repository to do an spdx license
identifier, we just say spdx
license identifier, and we're
gonna choose MIT, the MIT
license is one of the least
restrictive licenses out there.
So we use the MIT license for
most of our code samples once
you have a version and once you
have Is this much written, we
can actually go ahead and write
to our compiler tab and scroll
down and hit Compile, that
little turn thing will go. And
in a minute, we'll see, this
contract is attempted to be
compiled. Since we actually
don't have a contract, we see no
contract compiled yet, but we
see the compiler automatically
switched to zero point 8.8.
compiling our code means taking
our more human readable code
like pragma, solidity and
transforming it into computer
code, or very specific
instructions for the computer to
use. We'll go over what a lot of
this machine level code or this
computer level code is doing in
a later section. If you're using
a Mac, you can also hit command
S, and it will run the compiler
for you as well. On Windows, it
might be Ctrl S, we can actually
choose the compiler version that
we want to use. However, if we
tell in our code to specifically
use zero, point 8.8, and we hit
the compile button, it'll
automatically switch to zero
point 8.8. However, if we use
the carrot thing, we get
specifically say, hey, we want
0.8 point 10, we can hit
compile, and it will compile
with 0.8 point 10. Because
again, remember, the carrot says
we want to use at least zero,
point eight, all the way up to
the latest version of 0.8. Now
let's stay on zero point 8.8.
The next thing that we're going
to do in our code is define our
contract. And to get a full
screen view, you can go ahead
and hit the compiler button to
get rid of it there. To start
defining our contract, we're
gonna go ahead and write the
word contract. This tells
solidity that the next pieces of
code is going to be a contract
contract is a key word in
solidity, and it tells our
compiler that the next section
of this code is going to define
a contract. You can think of a
contract similar to a class in
any object oriented programming
like Java or JavaScript. Let's
go ahead and give our contract a
name here, we're going to call
RS simple storage. And then we
add this little open and close
curly brackets. Everything
inside this open and close curly
brackets is going to be the
contents of this contract.
Simple Storage. Now, if we go
ahead and hit command S or Ctrl
S, we can see this little green
checkmark show up. And if you
don't, you can always go back to
the compiler tab, scroll down
and hit Compile and see the
little green checkmark. That
little green checkmark means
that our code is compiling
successfully. And we don't have
any errors, we could
hypothetically deploy this
contract right now. And it would
be a valid contract. So
congratulations on writing your
first contract.
Now solidity has multiple
different types or primitive
data types. And if you go to the
solidity documentation, which
again, is in our GitHub
repository, you can read more
and learn more about the
different types that are in
here. The four most basic types
are going to be Boolean,
you int, int, and an address
or bytes, which is a lower level
type, which we'll talk about a
little bit later. A boolean
define some type of true false,
a you int is going to be an
unsigned integer, which means
it's going to be a whole number
that isn't positive or negative.
It's just positive, we have an
integer, which is going to be a
positive or negative whole
number. And then we have an
address, which is going to be an
address, like what we see in our
meta mask here. There are some
other types as well that you'll
learn later on. The reason that
we have these types is we use
them to define what different
variables are. Variables are
basically holders for different
values. For example, we could
create a variable called has
favorite number to represent if
somebody has a favorite number.
And we would put this bull
keyword before has to renumber
say, Okay, we have a variable
called has favorite number, and
it's of type boolean. So this
has favorite number is going to
represent a true or a false to
set its value, we could say has
favorite number equals true. Now
has favorite number is going to
be true. We could also say has
favorite number equals false. So
this Boolean has faded number is
now going to be false. For uns
we could say you went favorite
number equals and then set a
number 123. This means that our
favorite number is going to be
123 You'll enter is special
because we can actually specify
how many bits want to allocate
to this number bits and bytes
are pretty fundamental pieces of
information for computer
science. We're not going to go
over it here. However, there's a
fantastic video in the GitHub
repository that explains it
more. Basically, it's how much
storage or memory to allocate to
this number. How big can it get,
if we say a you int eight can
have eight bits all the way up
to you went to 56. If you don't
specify how big it is, it
automatically defaults to you
into 256. Oftentimes, it's
better when writing our code to
be very explicit. So usually
you'll see me just do you int
256 to represent a un 256. We
could also do an int favorite
number equals 123 or an int 256.
I'm just Going to go ahead and
add this Boolean back here,
we're going to change this back
to UNT to 36. And let's change
our favorite number to five
here, we could also do something
called strings, string, favorite
number in text
equals five
strings represent basically
words, and you can represent
them by putting them in these
quotes, it's going to be some
word or phrase, or really,
really just kind of any
combination of keystrokes in
here, our ends can be positive
or negative. So we could say,
negative five or positive five,
both are going to be valid,
since we can also do address my
address equals and grab our
address, right from Metamask.
And paste it in, you'll notice
that we end all of these lines
of code with the semicolon. We
also have bytes objects, or a
bytes 32, again, representing
how many bytes we want them to
be. And this says that we have
called favorite bytes, and we're
just gonna set it equal to cat.
So strings are actually really
interesting, because strings are
secretly just bytes objects, but
only for text to a cat is
actually a string, but can
automatically get converted into
one of these bytes object bytes,
objects typically look like 0x.
And then some random letters and
numbers that represent the bytes
object, but cat can
automatically get converted down
to bytes. We'll talk about bytes
more in coming sessions, you can
also do bytes, two bytes, three
bytes, five bytes 22, you get
the picture for our uns and our
into the sixth lowest we can go
is eight bits, because eight
bits is a byte. And we can go up
by steps of eight. So we can do
816 32, etc, all the way to 256.
For example, down here, we can't
do bytes 64. And if we go ahead
and try to compile this, we get
a little red thing here. And if
we scroll down, we get a
declaration error identifier not
found or not unique. Bytes 64
favorite bytes equals cats. And
we even got a little red warning
sign here in our remix. This is
remix telling us there's
something wrong with this line.
So we can switch back to bite
32. Since byte 32 is the maximum
size that a bytes can be, you
could also do just a bytes
object, which means it can have
any size, but we typically want
to be explicit. And we're going
to stick with bytes 32 For now
want to learn more about the
different types and how to use
them and all the different
features with them, be sure to
check out the solidity
documentation. For now for our
simple storage, let's say we
only want to store numbers. So
let's go ahead and delete
everything except for the
favorite number section.
Now in solidity,
if I do this, and I remove the
equals five, this favorite
number actually does get set to
a default value, the default
value for solidity is going to
be whatever the null value is,
which in solidity is case zero.
So saying you Intuit six
favorite number is going to be
the same as saying you 256
favorite number equals zero
since it gets initialized to
zero. So for now, let's not
initialize it to anything. So
that favorite number will
automatically start off as zero.
Now, if you get confused, as
you're coding along, and you're
following along with me, be sure
to write comments in your code
so you know what's going on. So
maybe, for example, a great
comment here would be this gets
initially alized to zero. And
then if that's even confusing,
you could say, this means that
this section is a comment. Now
let's go ahead and create a
function functions or methods
are self contained modules that
will execute some specific set
of instructions for us, when we
call it if you're familiar with
Java, or Python, or JavaScript
or anything like that functions
work the exact same way
functions get identified by the
keyword function, let's create a
function called store that will
change the value of favorite
number to some new value. And
the number that we're going to
change it to is going to be
variables that are passed to our
store function here. So we're
going to allow our store
function to take a variable of
type un 256. And we'll call it
underscore favorite
number, we'll make this a public
function, which we'll get to in
a minute. And all we're going to
do is we're going to set
favorite number equal to
whatever variable that we just
passed. So now we have this
function called store, that it
takes some parameter that we're
going to give it and it sets
this favorite number variable
equal to whatever number that we
give this function. Now to see
this actually in action, let's
deploy this to an even thicker
blockchain than a test net.
We're going to actually deploy
this to a local network or a
JavaScript VM. And first before
we can even do that, let's just
make sure that it's going
compiling correctly looks like
we have a green checkmark, which
is good. And we'll come down to
this button here, which is our
deploy and run Transactions tab.
Our deploy and run Transactions
tab has a ton of different
configuration pieces for
actually deploying this
contract. First, we want to make
sure we are on the JavaScript VM
London piece here, JavaScript VM
means we're going to be
deploying to a fake local
JavaScript VM. The JavaScript VM
is a fake local blockchain where
we can simulate transactions
really quickly without having to
wait for them to go through on a
test net, don't worry about the
London versus Berlin piece here
for now, injected web three and
web three provider we'll talk
about in a little bit. We also
have this account section here.
When we run on our fake
JavaScript VM, we're given a
whole bunch of fake accounts
from where to deploy from, and
we're given 100 eath. For each
one of these fake accounts, you
can kind of think of it similar
to our meta mask account in meta
mask, except for the difference
here is that this is this fake
JavaScript VM Aetherium that
we're given. For our
transactions, including
deploying contracts, we're
actually given a gas limit,
there's also values we can send,
and we can choose our contracts.
Right now we only have one
contract, simple storage, so
that's going to be the one that
we're going to deploy. So on the
left hand side, to deploy this
to our fake JavaScript VM, we're
gonna go ahead and hit the
Deploy button. And if we scroll
all the way down to the bottom,
now, we can see a contract was
deployed. It says simple storage
at x, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And we see this orange
button store with come this
grade text you in 256,
underscore favorite number on
our fake local blockchain, we're
actually given an address every
single smart contract, it has an
address, just like how our
wallets have an address. So if
we hit this copy button here,
and we put it into a comment,
make this a little bit bigger,
we can see that the address of
this contract that we just
deployed, is located at this
address. Additionally, if you
pull up the slider over here,
you'll be able to see this
little green checkmark with all
this information about this
deployment. And you can hit the
little drop down and see a whole
lot more information about this.
Something you might notice is
you'll see some familiar
keywords like status,
transaction hash, from to gas,
etc. When we deploy a contract,
it's actually the same as
sending a transaction. Remember,
anytime we do anything on the
blockchain, we modify any value,
we are sending a transaction. So
deploying a contract is
modifying the blockchain to have
this contract, it's modifying
the state of the blockchain. And
if we had sent this on a
Rinkeby, or COVID, or main net
network, we would have had to
spend the gas to actually deploy
this contract. And this is the
simulation of how much gas and
the transaction hash and from
and to and all this other stuff
about our transaction had, we
actually deployed it to a real
network. But since it's
JavaScript VM, it's all fake
information. Now we have this
big orange button store, this
big orange button resembles the
store function that we just
created. So if we add some
number into this store, like
123, and we hit the Store
button, we actually call this
store button. And we actually
execute a transaction on our
fake Jasika. Blockchain to store
the number 1234 favorite number.
And if we scroll all the way up
to our account, now, you'll see
that we have a little bit less
ether in our fake account. This
is because we spent the gas to
actually call this contract. And
if we pull up this bottom bit
here, and I call this with five
I call store, you'll see it
flashed for a quick second, we
sent another transaction to
store the value five in our
favorite number. Now the
question might be having is,
that's really cool, Patrick, but
I can't see what favorite number
actually is, how do I know that
those transactions are actually
going through? Well, right now,
the visibility of our favorite
number is set to private, so we
actually can't see it. And we'll
talk about visibility in just a
second. To make it so that we
can see it. We'll change our
favorite numbers visibility to
public. So let's go ahead, we'll
recompile we'll go back to the
deploy tab. We'll click the
little x here, which is to say
let's get rid of this contract.
And it just gets rid of it from
our window here. It doesn't
actually get rid of it from the
blockchain, because again,
they're immutable, well, kind of
immutable, since again, this is
kind of a fake simulated chain.
But we go ahead and compile, and
now we hit Deploy again. And if
we scroll down, our new
contract, will now have two
buttons. One is the orange
button for store. But now we
have a New Favorite button. This
button represents this public
variable favorite number, and it
resembles a function saying,
Hey, show me what favorite
number is. So if I were to click
this favorite number button,
what do you think will show up?
Well, do you remember what this
gets initialized to? Well, let's
click it now. We do indeed See
that zero shows up, we see that
this is a YouTube ID six, and
the value stored in it is zero.
Now, if I were to change that
number to five by calling the
store function, and now hitting
favorite number, we do indeed
see, favorite number gets
updated to five functions and
variables can have one for
visibility specifiers, we have
public, private, external, and
internal. Public is visible
externally and internally,
meaning anybody who interacts
with this contract or sees this
contract can see what's stored
in this favorite number
function. You'll see here in the
solidity documentation, it says
it creates a getter function for
the storage slash state
variables. When we add this
keyword public to favorite
number, what we're actually
doing is we're creating what's
called a getter function for
favorite number, we're basically
creating a function that says to
return the value of favorite
number, and that's why this blue
button pops up. Because this
blue button is a function that
says, hey, return the value of
favorite number private means
only this specific contract can
call this function. Now for
storage, it doesn't mean only
this contract can read what's
stored here. And we'll get into
that a little bit later. But by
that means, this is the only
contract that can call the
favorite number function.
Private functions are only
visible to the current contract.
External functions are only
visible externally, meaning
somebody outside this contract
can call this function. And then
internal means that only this
contract and it's children
contracts can actually read it,
but we'll get into that a little
bit later, too. So oddly enough,
variables are just function
calls. Now, the reason that we
didn't see favorite numbers show
up on the left hand side, when
we first deployed this without
the public keyword. When we
don't give a visibility
specifier to functions or
variables, they automatically
get deployed as internal. And as
we know, internal functions and
variables can only be called by
this specific contract or
derived contracts, which again,
we'll get into later. So let's
just keep it public. For now,
the reason that we're prefixing,
our parameter here with an
underscore is a way to tell us,
hey, this variable here is
different from the favorite
number global, there are some
different naming conventions
that are used for parameters.
And as we get later into the
course, will understand more and
more of what good names are
parameters are, every time we
call this store function. And we
change the value here, we're
actually sending a transaction
because remember, every single
time we change the state of the
blockchain, we do it in a
transaction. And we can see all
the details here. If you go over
to the transaction details in
the logging area of your remix,
you can actually scroll down and
you can see the transaction cost
in units of gas, you'll see a
number of something around this.
And you'll notice it's more than
that 21,000 number from sending
Aetherium. That's because we're
doing something more
computationally expensive. We're
actually storing a number over
here. Now what do you think will
happen if we do more inside of
the store function as well. So
instead of just storing this
number, maybe what else we do is
we will store the number here.
And then we'll update our
favorite number will say
favorite number equals favorite
number plus one. Since we're
doing more stuff, now we should
see this store function actually
become more expensive. So let's
go ahead and recompile we'll do
delete this will redeploy. We
now have a new contract will
store five again. Now if we look
in the details of this
transaction, and we scroll down
to execution costs, we do indeed
see the amount of gas has
greatly increased. And that's
because we're doing more things,
this store function is now more
computationally expensive. And
like I said, each blockchain has
a little different way of how
they actually calculate gas. But
the easiest way to think about
it is, the more stuff you do,
the more expensive that
transaction is going to cost. So
let's go ahead and delete this
line to continue our example.
Now let's talk about scope for a
second, our favorite number is
basically in something called
the global scope, meaning
anything inside of these
brackets can access this
favorite number variable. But
what if I did something like
this? What if I made a un 256
called Test var? And I set it
equal to five? And then I
created a new function called
something will have it take no
parameters and be public? Could
I access the test var and then
change it to something like six?
Can we do that? Well, let's go
ahead and see what happens when
we try to compile this. We
actually run into an error. We
had expected primary expression
right here. Oh, well, that's
because I have the double
question mark. Let's try now. We
get undeclared identifier. Our
something function doesn't know
about this test var when you
create variables, they only can
be viewed in the scope of where
they are. Now if that's a little
confusing, just look for the
curly brackets. These two curly
brackets encompass this whole
We'll section here write, the
opening one is up here, the
closing one is down here. So if
I create a variable directly
inside of these curly brackets,
that means everything in here
can access it. However, test var
was created inside of these
curly brackets, which means that
only stuff inside of these curly
brackets can access test var,
since our functions something
isn't inside of store, or
something function won't know
about test var. So that's how
scope works, you want to look to
see if your variable that you
created is inside of these curly
brackets. And that's how you can
know if other functions can work
with them. So this is why this
fails. Now, like what we saw in
the documentation, when we add
this public variable to favorite
number, we're secretly adding a
function that just returns this
favorite number, we can also add
our own function that also
returns the favorite number to
resemble the function that's
getting created in the backend.
So we can say function, we call
it retrieve, and we make it a
public view. And we'll say it
returns, you went to 56. or
explain what that means in just
a second. And we'll say return
favorite number. Now, I'm going
to hit command S, which again,
I'm going to do that a lot
throughout this section. But
just remember that that's
equivalent to me going to the
compile tab and hitting compile.
Now if we go to the deploy tab,
delete our last one, deploy a
new one, we now have a retrieve
function, which is going to
return the exact same thing that
our favorite number is going to
return. Again, if we update this
to five, called favorite number
and then retrieve they both now
return five. Now as you can see
here, these two functions are
blue, but this function is
orange. What's the difference?
Why did these have these
different colors? Well, the key
lies in this view keyword here,
there are actually two keywords
in solidity that notate a
function that doesn't actually
have to spend gas to run. And
those keywords are view, and
pure. And let's also get rid of
this variable here. A function
that is a view function means
we're just going to read state
from this contract, we're just
going to read something off of
this contract. For example, our
retrieve function right now is
just reading what favorite
number is, a view function
disallows any modification of
state. So you can't update the
blockchain at all with a view
function. Pure functions also
disallow any modification of
state. So we couldn't update our
favorite number. Not only that,
but they also disallow reading
from the blockchain. So we
couldn't read favorite number
either. Instead, what you might
do with a pure function is maybe
something like
function, add public here, one
plus one,
or return, one plus one, this
would be turns you into 36,
maybe something like this, maybe
there's some math you want to
use over and over again, maybe
there's some specific algorithm
that you want to implement that
doesn't actually need to read
any storage, etc. Now, if we
call a view function, or a pure
function by itself, we actually
don't need to spend any gas.
Since we're just reading from
the blockchain. Remember, we
only spend gas we only make a
transaction if we modify the
blockchain state. So you'll
notice in our little console
down here, that if I call
retrieve this call things comes
up. However, it looks different
than when we call the store
function. And we call the store
function, we get this little
checkmark, we get a hash, we
don't get a little checkmark.
And we don't get a hash with the
calls. That's because clicking
these blue buttons doesn't make
a transaction. This is saying,
Hey, we're just going to read
off chain, we're just going to
read this value. However, if you
look in the details of this
call, there's this execution
cost bit here. So what's going
on? Well, we can read this part
right here, cost only applies
when called by contract. If we
do have a function that calls
retrieve, if there's a function
that is updating state that
calls a view or a pure function,
that's the only time it'll cost
gas. So for example, if our
store function which is not a
view function, were to call
retrieve at some point, then
we'd have to pay the cost of the
Retrieve because reading from
the blockchain cost this
computation and cost gas calling
view functions is free, unless
you're calling it inside of a
function that costs gas, in
which case it will cost gas. So
if we leave it here, we delete
this recompile redeploy. We had
favorite number retrieved, they
both still cost nothing. But if
we add, restore eight in here,
we can see, we can see our
execution cost has gone up from
what it was without retrieve,
which we can go ahead, we can
compile, I hit command us to
compile here, we can deploy.
Let's go ahead and store again.
We'll click on that transaction,
we can see that it's much
cheaper without that retrieve
function in there. And again,
our favorite number variable as
long as it has this public
visible solidity, it also is
counted as a view function that
returns a un 256. The returns
keyword means what is this
function going to give us after
we call it so we say this
function is going to give us
this function is going to return
a un 256. When we call retrieve,
it's going to return or give us
a utility six. This is the
result of calling the function
this six is the result of
calling arbitrary function.
Now our contract is
good as it is, it allows us to
store a single favorite number.
But what if we want to store a
range of favorite numbers? Or
maybe we want to store a whole
bunch of different people who
have different favorite numbers?
Well, how do we do that there
are several different ways that
we can approach this, one of the
ways we could start approaching
this is by creating what's
called a struct of people. Or we
create a new type. In our
solidity, we can create a people
object that holds both someone's
name, and their favorite number.
To do that, we say struct
people, you went to 56, favorite
number, and a string name. Now
we've created a new type called
people kinda like you intuited
six, or Boolean, or string. Now
we have a people type that we
can use. Now similar to how we
created a un 256 public favorite
number, we can do the exact same
thing. But with a people, we
could say people public, we call
this person, and we can create a
new people and assign it to this
variable person. So we'll say
equals people public person,
equals, and we'll add
parentheses here to signify
we're creating a new person. And
since we made this a struct, we
add little curly brackets here
to let solidity know that we're
going to be grabbing from these
struct variables, we'll say
favorite number is going to be
two, and the name is going to be
Patrick semicolon, and then we
can hit Ctrl S, or we can go
ahead and compile. Now if we go
ahead and deploy this we now
have a new person, since this,
again, is a public variable, it
has a getter function called
person. And if we click person,
we see our new object, the
favorite number is two. And then
the name is Patrick, you see
this zero and this one, because
these are showing the index of
the different variables. But
those of you new to computer
science, typically in computer
science, let's start with the
number zero. So what are zero
with index, we have you in 256,
called favorite number, which is
saved at two. And then at index
one, we have a string, which
stands for the name of Patrick,
whenever you have a list of
variables inside of an object in
solidity, they get automatically
indexed. So favorite number gets
indexed to zero, and name gets
indexed to one. Interestingly
enough, if you have a whole
bunch of variables inside your
contract, like we have public
favorite number, this favorite
number, actually, technically is
getting indexed at the zero with
storage slot. And if we were to
make another one of these, maybe
you want to get six public
brother's favorite number, this
would technically be indexed at
the first slot. And then if we
were to make one more, maybe
sister's favorite number, this
would be the next add the second
slot. So favorite number at
zero, this add one, and this a
two, but we'll learn more about
that much later in the course.
Similarly, favorite number is
index zero name is index at one.
Now what we have is great, but
if we want a whole lot of people
are we gonna have to keep copy
pasting and changing the
people's name person to their
favorite one, number one, number
three, will name them ally.
Person three, their favorite
number will be seven. Their name
will be Chad or something. This
obviously isn't great way to
create lists and large number of
people's because we have to
statically keep typing them in.
So a much better way to create a
list. And let's actually just go
ahead and delete Patrick to a
much better way to create a list
is to use a data structure
called an array. An array is a
way to store a list, or a
sequence of objects, creating an
array works the exact same we've
seen to initialize other
different types. Typically, we
do the type of the object, the
visibility of the object, and
then the variable name. We do
the exact same thing with
arrays. We'll say we want a
people array. These little
brackets represent that we want
an array of people. We'll give
it a visibility of public and
we'll call it people you could
do the same thing with you and
256 for example, you could say
you went to 56
public favorite numbers list
and just add this little array
key here. And now favorite
numbers list is going to be an
array or a list We're going to
comment that out for now. Now if
I were to go ahead and deploy
this contract, let's go ahead
delete the last one, let's
redeploy. We now have this blue
people button here. Remember,
since it's public, and it's a
variable, it automatically is
given a view function, it's
given one of these blue buttons.
And instead of just having a
single button where the value
shows up, it's giving us a form
to fill out, it wants to take a
un 256 as an input parameter. So
if I put zero, I get nothing
back, if I put one, I get
nothing back. No matter what you
put in this box, right? Now
we're gonna get nothing back.
This is because our people array
or our people list is currently
empty. And the value that it
wants is going to be the index
of the object that you want. So
for example, if at index zero, I
had Patrick, it would show
Patrick for zero, if it didn't x
one I had John, or actually
better yet, to Patrick.
Seven, John,
etc. This is what it would show.
But since it's empty, it's going
to show nothing. And let's go
ahead and remove the public
variable from favorite numbers
so that we don't get the
duplicate functions at the
moment, we'll just get the
Retrieve function, we'll show
you how to add to this array in
just a second. This type of
array is what's known as a
dynamic array, because the size
of the array isn't given at the
array initialization. If we were
to say, a people array and add a
three in these brackets here,
that means that this list, or
this array of people could only
be three people big, if we don't
give it a size, it means it can
be any size and the size of the
array can grow and shrink as we
add and subtract people, if I
add three, it can only have a
maximum of three in the array
ever, we're going to work with a
dynamic array, because we're
going to want to add a arbitrary
number of people to this array.
So let's go ahead and create a
function that's going to add
people who are people array, so
we're gonna say function, add
person. And we're going to take
string, memory, name as input
parameter, and I'll explain that
in a minute. And a un 256
underscore favorite number,
we're going to make this a
public function, or we're going
to do is we're going to call a
push function that's available
on our people object. So we're
gonna say people dot push, and
we're going to create a new
person, a new people object,
which is going to take in the
favorite number.
And the name.
Now, this might be a little bit
tricky to you. So let's break
this down. People here is
capitalized. So we know that
since capitalize, it's referring
to this struct people and not
our variable people, the
lowercase people here is
referring to this lowercase
array. So we're saying our array
dot push, or push is the
equivalent of adding basically,
a new people that grabs favorite
number and name. Another way
that we could actually do this
is we could create a variable of
type people and then add it like
so. So we could say people, new
person equals people. And then
we put those brackets the same
way we did before. You say
favorite number is going to be
this input value, this
parameter, and we could say name
is going to be this parameter.
Now if you hit save, you'll get
this error set here, saying data
location must be stored in
memory, or called data for
variable but no one's given. For
now, we're just going to add the
memory keyword here, and I'll
explain what it does in a little
bit. And then of course, we need
to add the new person into our
people dot push right here. So
this is how we're actually going
to push people into our people
array. And I'll get to this
memory keyword in a bit. Now if
we go back to our deploy tab, we
delete our last contract. Let's
deploy this new one. Right now,
if we try to look at the zero
with person in our people array,
we get nothing but let's go
ahead and add a person, we'll
call it, Patrick will be the
name, and seven will be the
favorite number. So we added
Patrick, we added seven. Now if
we look at people's zero, we
should see the zeroeth person
has a name of Patrick, and a
favorite number of seven, boom.
And that's exactly what we do
see, we see a favorite number of
seven, and we see a string name
Patrick, we tried to add John
and do his 16. We hit Add
Person, we can see our
transaction go through. And now
if we go to people at zero, it's
still Patrick with a favorite
number of seven. But if we look
at the people at index one, it's
going to be John with a favorite
number of 16. And if we look at
two, this, of course, should be
blank. And we do indeed see
nothing actually happens here.
Perfect. Now there's actually a
couple of different ways to
create this new person here,
like we showed before, we can
use this bracket notation, or
what we can do is we can
actually just add the parameters
in the order that they show. So
the first parameter for people
is going to be favorite number.
So we can just do favorite
number, comma, and the second
one is going to be name, the
second one is going to be name.
So if we save this, this, this
line we just created is the
exact same as the last line,
we're being a little bit less
explicit here. So the other way
is generally a little bit better
because it's more explicit as to
what variables are what or we
don't even need to save to this
variable here, we could take out
this whole line, replace new
person with exactly what we just
saw, like so now we don't even
need the memory keyword. Now,
you've probably seen this by
now. But if I go ahead and
compile, and I see a little,
little red one here, I roll
over. And it says something
about error, expected semicolon,
but got bracket, all these
errors mean that your code isn't
compiling. It's not working as
expected. So now I can go over
here and do a little semicolon
recompile, and I get a green.
Now if I delete this top line,
for example, and I compile it,
actually get a yellow thing.
Yellow stands for warnings, the
warning that I get is warning
SPX license identifier, not
provided, you should add it. So
let's go ahead and add that
back. recompile. And the warning
goes away. Warnings Don't stop
your code from compiling. So if
you get warnings, it's okay. But
it's usually a good idea to
listen to the warnings, because
often they'll give really
insightful information about how
to improve your smart contracts.
So to summarize, if it's red,
it's broken. If it's yellow, you
might want to check it out. But
it won't stop you from
continuing to code. So one thing
that you'll notice here is that
we have this memory keyword. And
you'll notice if you try to
delete it from our function
here, you try to compile, you
actually run into an error data
location must be memory or call
data for parameter and function.
Now there are actually six
places you can store data in
solidity you have the stack,
memory, storage, call data, code
and logs. We're not going to go
over these right now. But we are
going to focus on three of the
big ones, or three of the
important ones for this section,
which are called data, memory,
and storage. So for this
section, we're going to talk
about call data memory and
storage. And this is a little
bit advanced. So if you don't
totally grasp it the first time,
that's totally okay. Please
continue. Even if it's not
crystal clear what's going on
here, call data and memory mean
that the variable is only going
to exist temporarily. So this
name variable only exists
temporarily during the
transaction that this Add Person
function is called storage
variables exist, even outside of
just the function executing.
Even though we didn't specify it
up above, our favorite number is
automatically cast to be a
storage variable. Since it's not
explicitly defined in one of
these functions. Since we don't
need this name variable anymore
after this function runs, we can
keep it as memory, or we could
keep it as called data, you can
have a parameter as called data
if you don't end up modifying
the name. For example, we
couldn't reassign name to equal
cat here, if we compile we run
into an error. Type literal
string cat is not implicitly
convertible to expect the type
string called data. However, if
we have this as memory, and we
compile and save it, that error
goes away call data is temporary
variables that can't be
modified. Memory is temporary
variables that can be modified.
And storage is permanent
Now even though I just said
there's actually six places
where we can access and store
information, we cannot say a
variable is stack code or logs,
we can only say memory storage
are called data, you will learn
why in a much later section.
Now, this is a bit of an
oversimplification of this. But
that's essentially what's going
on. The next question you might
have is, well, why do I need to
say memory here, but I don't
need to say memory here. Well,
let's go ahead and put memory
here and hit CTRL S or compile.
And let's see what happens we
get from solidity data location
can only be specified for an
array, struct or mapping types.
A memory was given arrays
structs and mappings are
considered special types and
solidity. solidity automatically
knows where are you in 256 is
going to be slowly knows that
for this function, a un 256 is
going to live just in memory.
However, it's not sure what a
string is going to be. Strings
are actually kind of
complicated. Behind the scenes,
a string is actually an array of
bytes. And since a string is an
array, we need to add this
memory bit to it because we need
to tell solidity, the data
location of arrays structs, or
mappings and a string is
secretly an array. So that's why
we need to tell it it's in
memory. You'll notice we can't
add the storage keyword here
slowly also knows that since
this is a function, this name
variable isn't actually getting
stored anywhere. So it says Hey,
you can't have that you need to
have it beat memory or called
data and those are the only two
that it accepts So this is what
we want our function to look
like here. So the summary of
this is struct mappings and
arrays need to be given this
memory or called Data keyword
when adding them as a parameter
to different functions. We'll
learn more about storage memory
and call data in later
sessions. Now, this list
is great, but what if we know
someone's name, but we don't
know their favorite number?
Well, what we could do is we
could look through the whole
array looking for that person.
For example, in our contract, we
can say, Okay, I'm looking for
John. Okay, let's start with
zero. No, okay, that's Patrick.
Okay, let's go to one. Okay.
That's John. Oh, great. His
favorite number 16? Well, this
was really easy, because we only
had two people. But what if we
had hundreds of people in this
array? Well, we'd keep have to
iterating all the way up to the
index that that person was in,
it's obviously really
inefficient. What's another way
to store this information so
that it's much easier and
quicker to access? Well, another
data structure that we can use
is something called a mapping,
you can think of a mapping as
sort of like a dictionary, it's
a set of keys, which each key
returning a certain value
associated with that key. And we
create a mapping variable the
exact same way we create all of
our other variables. This is
going to be a type mapping of
string
to you and tivity sex,
this is going to be our type of
visibility keyword is going to
be public. And we'll call it
name to favorite number. Now we
have a dictionary where every
single name is going to map to a
specific number. So let's add
some capability to our Add
Person function. So we are going
to add our people to our array.
But let's also add them to our
mapping here, what we'll do is
we'll say name to favorite
number. App key name is going to
equal to
favorite number. So let's go
ahead, compile this.
We'll go to our deploy screen,
we'll deploy this click, we have
a new button named a favorite
number. If I type in Patrick,
nothing shows up. By typing
Patrick, you'll see I get zero
response. By typing John, I also
get a zero response. If I type
in Becca, I also get a with zero
response. When you create a
mapping, you initialize
everything to its null value,
every single possible string on
the planet right now is
initialized to having a favorite
number of zero. So if we want to
change that, we'll have to go in
and manually add that. So let's
go ahead and add a person to our
mapping here. So we'll add
Patrick. And we'll say my
favorite number is seven. And
looks like that transaction did
go through also add, Becca, and
we'll say her favorite number is
13. Let John and we'll say his
favorite number is 16. Now, if I
look up, Patrick, I'll
immediately get back what
Patrick's favorite number is, I
get seven back. If we look up,
John, we immediately get back
16. Back up, we may only get
back 13. And we also can see
them in our array. Because we
kept in this people that push
bit zero, we see Patrick's
there. At one, we see Becca. And
at two, we see John, in our
mapping, we're saying the string
name is being mapped to the UN
256 favorite number. And a lot
of my variables, I like to make
them explicitly named like that.
So this is name to
favorite number. So
now we're in a space where let's
say that we really like our
simple storage contract. Right
now we have a favorite number, a
global variable that we can save
a favorite number to with our
store function, we have a
mapping of name to favorite
numbers, and we have an array of
a new type that we created
called people, we can add to
both the array and to the
mapping. Using this Add Person
function that we've created,
we're able to save multiple
people's favorite numbers as
well as kind of a global
favorite number as well. Let's
say we really love this
contract, and we're ready to
send it to a test net to have
other people interact with it.
Now in future sections, you'll
hear me say that you shouldn't
do this until you write tests
until you do some really simple
auditing. But for now, let's go
ahead and learn how to actually
deploy this to a test net or to
a real network. Now remember,
test nets are run out of the
goodness of people's hearts. So
if it's a little bit funky, or
maybe doesn't work exactly as we
show here, that's okay. As long
as it works with the JavaScript
VM, you'll be all set but it is
good practice to learn how to
deploy these to a real test net.
Let's go ahead and do that. Our
contract is here. Simple Storage
dot soul. It's compiled,
compiling is passing we get this
little green checkmark here we
go to the deploy section. Let's
go ahead and do Get this. And
now we're going to change the
environment. So we were working
with a JavaScript VM or kind of
this fake simulated environment,
we want to now move to either
injected web three, or web three
provider. If you hover over
injected web three, there's this
really, really small text here.
But this basically means we're
going to inject our meta mask or
our web three wallet into our
browser to use similar to what
we did with the faucet, we'll
pick our account we want to use.
So I'm gonna go ahead and pick
account one. And now we actually
see our account in the Account
section of remix, injected web
three means we're using our meta
mask or whatever web three
wallet, web three provider is,
when we a little bit more
manually choose an endpoint. And
we're not going to go over this
right now. But as we get later
into the course, you'll
understand what this means. So
we're picking injected web
three, whatever network are
injected web three, or in this
case, our wallet is connected to
is going to be the network that
we deploy to. So for this
section, we're going to be
deploying to Rinkeby. But again,
depending on whatever the
recommended test net and the
recommended faucet is, that will
dictate which test net you
should actually deploy to. For
us, it's going to be Rigby. To
deploy to a test that remember,
we're going to need gas, so
we're going to need some tested
Etherium. Or if you're deploying
to a main net main Aetherium,
which you shouldn't be come to
the top of the GitHub repo to
make sure you have the most
updated faucet, the other place
you can go is link token
contracts page in the chain link
documentation and scroll down
the ranking. And you can see
test that link available here,
test that eath available here.
So this is the other location,
you can always look to find the
most up to date faucets, and
both of them point right back
here. So now that we're working
with injected web three, we can
just go through the exact same
steps to deploy to a test net as
to deploy to a virtual machine.
And remember, if you run out of
gas to deploy this, be sure to
check back to the faucets to
actually deploy this. So we're
going to do the same thing,
we're gonna go ahead and hit
Deploy. But this time Metamask
is going to pop up and ask us if
we want to actually deploy this,
this is the exact same as what
we saw with the blockchain
example, where we sign
transactions, we are signing and
sending this transaction, the
data of this transaction is this
massive, massive data thing
here, which represents the
contract that we just created,
we can see all the payment
information for this transaction
for deploying this contract, we
see it's going to cost around
this much Aetherium to deploy.
But again, we're on the Rinkeby
test network. So this is going
to be fake Aetherium. We're
gonna go ahead, hit Confirm. And
if you pop up a little console,
and remix, you'll see that after
a slight delay, it'll actually
say have this green checkmark
that it's confirmed that it went
actually went through, we can go
ahead right click, open a new
tab, and view this on ether
scan. And after a slight delay,
we'll actually be able to see
the transaction details here,
exactly the same as our
transaction details for sending
Aetherium we have a hash, we
have a status, we have blocked
block confirmations, we have
timestamp from which is going to
be us two, which is going to be
the average of the contract that
we just created. We didn't send
any value with this. So this is
going to be zero ether. And then
of course, we see the
transaction fee, and as well as
the gas price. Because again,
deploying a contract to the
blockchain is modifying the
state of the blockchain. So we
have to pay gas, and we can see
all the different pieces here.
As we can see, gas limit and gas
usage is much higher than just
sending Aetherium, since we are
putting a lot of data on chain
and adding a lot of computation.
So this number is much higher
than the 21,000 number of just
sending Aetherium. Now, if we
come back to our remix and
scroll down, we're able to see
our simple storage contract at
this address. If we hit this
copy button, and we go to the
rink be ether scan, we paste it
in the search bar, we will get
the contract that we just
deployed. And we see this first
transaction is going to be the
contract creation transaction.
So this contract that we just
created one transaction, which
is contract created. So now that
we have this contract created,
we have all the exact same
functions that we saw when
working with the JavaScript
virtual machine, or the our fake
environment, or our super fake
environment. Now we can do all
the exact same things that we
did with the JavaScript VM, but
on a real test network. So
you'll see if I hit retrieve
Metamask doesn't pop up. Because
again, this is a blue view
function. If we look people at
zero, this is also a view
function and nothing pops up,
named a favorite number should
be blank. So if I type in
Patrick now, absolutely nothing
happens, right? I get I get zero
returned because mappings
initialize every single key with
a blank or a null value, which
for you 256 is zero. Now, we can
go ahead and store a favorite
number store When your favorite
number is going to modify the
blockchain, so our meta mask
should pop up for us to confirm
the transaction and sign that
transaction to modify the
blockchain state. So I'm going
to store my favorite number of
16, we'll hit store, meta mask
will pop up, and we're going to
go ahead and actually confirm
this didn't confirm is
equivalent to US signing this
transaction and sending it to
the blockchain to modify the
state. So we're gonna go ahead
and confirm this, we should be
able to view this on ether scan.
And again, it might take a
little bit for it to actually
index or actually start working.
So please be patient with these
test nets. And again, this is
why when building your
applications, you want the test
net piece to absolutely try to
be your last step, because you
have to wait a really long time.
And it puts a burden on these
people running these tests into
running it out of the goodness
of their heart. So please try to
make this the last step of your
actual building process. For us
learning right here, it's okay.
And after a slight delay, once
we hit refresh, it looks like
it's indexing on ether scan, the
ether scan website is still
figuring out where the
transaction is going to remix,
it looks like on the blockchain,
this has actually already gone
through. So now if we hit
retrieve, we do indeed see, our
favorite number is 16. Of
course, these two are still
going to be blank. And it looks
like that transaction has gone
through and ether scan has
indexed. So now let's go ahead
and add a person will add
Patrick, and my favorite number
is going to be 16. We'll go
ahead and add person. Again,
since these are orange
transactions gonna pop up
because we're modifying the
blockchain state, we'll go ahead
and hit Confirm. And we're going
to be a little bit patient here
and wait for this transaction to
go through. And we should see
this update. And this update.
Now if I hit named a favorite
number of Patrick, I get 16. And
if I hit people of zero, I get
favorite number 16. And the name
is Patrick. Awesome. So you've
actually successfully deployed a
contract to an actual test net,
and actually seen on ether scan
what these transactions look
like, you should be incredibly
proud of yourself, be sure to
give yourself a high five pat on
the back, send a tweet saying
exactly how excited you are. But
make sure to celebrate these
little wins, celebrating these
little wins will give you the
motivation to keep going and
really excite you for learning
each new thing. So huge.
Congratulations. If you got this
far, you've deployed your first
contract to a test net,
congratulations. Now if you want
to see what it looks like to
deploy to a different network,
all you need to do in your
Metamask is switch to a
different test net. See, if we
switch to COVID remix
automatically updates and says,
ah, injected web three is now
the COVID test network. We could
switch again maybe to Grilley,
we say Ah, the injected web
three is now at the Grilley.
This is the test net that we'd
be deploying to of course, we
need actual test net Aetherium
to do any deploying, so we
wouldn't be able to here. And if
we go ahead and hit Deploy right
now Metamask pops up. But we get
this little red thing saying
insufficient funds. Of course,
later on, we'll learn how to add
new networks like polygon like
avalanche like phantom into our
Metamask. So we can deploy from
any one of them
as well.
Now, I mentioned this term
before, but all this code that
we wrote, when we hit this
compile button, it compiles it
down to the EVM or the Ethereum
virtual machine. Don't worry too
much about what this means. EVM
is a standard of how to deploy
smart contracts to Aetherium
like blockchains. And any
blockchain that implements a
type of EVM. You can deploy
solidity code to some examples
of EVM compatible blockchains
are going to be avalanche,
Phantom, and polygon. Since
these are EVM compatible, this
means we can write our solidity
code, and deploy to these
blockchains, which again, I'll
show you later on how to add
these new networks into your
Metamask. And then how to deploy
them. Let's do a quick recap of
our first smart contract. And
then you should actually take a
break, maybe get some ice cream
or coffee because you absolutely
deserve it. Congratulations. The
first thing you always need to
do in your smart contracts is
tell solidity, what version of
solidity that you're going to be
using. And additionally, you
want to add an spdx license
identifier, then you have to
create your contract object and
name your contract. The contract
in solidity is similar to a
class in other programming
languages, and everything inside
the squiggly brackets is a part
of that contract. There are many
different types in solidity like
unsigned integer, 256, Boolean
string, bytes, 32, etc. If we
want to create a new type, we
can create what's called a
struct in solidity. You can
create arrays or lists in
solidity, you can create
dictionaries, or what's called
mappings in solidity or hash
tables, which when you give it a
key, it'll spit out the value
that that key represents. We can
create functions in solidity
that modify the state of the
blockchain. We can also create
functions in solidity that don't
modify the state of the
blockchain view in pure
functions, don't modify by the
state of a blockchain, we also
can specify different data
locations in our functions,
called data and memory mean that
that data is only temporary and
will only exist for the duration
of the function. Storage
variables are permanent and stay
there forever. function
parameters can't be stored
variables because they're only
going to exist for the duration
of the function. All the
solidity code that we work with,
when we hit Compile, it actually
compiles down to this Aetherium
virtual machine specifications.
We'll learn more about those
specifications later. And last,
but not least, another huge
congratulations on your first
contract here.
Awesome.
All right, let's get started on
our lesson three, remember,
everything is in the GitHub
repository. And we can scroll
down, hit Lesson three and see
all the code here. I'm building
up this repo as I film. So
underneath this lesson three is
going to be a lot more
information than just the code
here, all of our code samples
end with dash f f, c, which
means dash Free Code Camp. So if
you see a GitHub repo that ends
with dash F, F, C, know that
that repository is associated
with this course, I'm going to
do a quick high level
walkthrough of what we're going
to be building in this lesson.
So you don't need to code right
now just sit back watch and
enjoy. In this lesson, we're
actually going to expand to
having three different
contracts. Let's say we want to
be able to deploy simple storage
contracts from a contract
itself. Yes, contracts can
indeed deploy contracts, we are
going to create a contract
called storage factory dot sole,
that's going to be able to
deploy and interact with other
contracts itself. So what we
could do is we could go deploy
this to a JavaScript VM, we're
going to choose storage factory,
and we're gonna go ahead and hit
Deploy. In our contract down
below, we have a number of
different functions. Our top
function is this function called
crate simple storage contract,
which we can click and it'll
actually create a simple storage
contract for us, then we can go
ahead and interact with it at an
IG zero will save a favorite
number of one. Now, if we hit SF
get zero,
we get one back. And
we can see the address of the
simple storage contract that we
just deployed. Additionally,
we're going to learn about a
number of solidity features,
such as importing inheritance,
and so much more. So let's go
ahead and jump in. And remember
all the code is available here
from the GitHub repository. So
be sure to refer back to these
contracts if you get lost.
So here we are
back in remix, and we have our
simple storage dot soul. If you
skipped over the last section,
be sure to go to the full
blockchain solidity course, Jas.
And scroll down to lesson two,
welcome to remix and grab this
code. Go to simple storage
outsole. And copy paste this
code into remix. Because this is
where we're going to be starting
from, we have this simple
storage contract, which is
great. It allows us to store a
favorite number. And it allows
us to store favorite numbers
across different people in both
mappings and arrays. But let's
say we want to get even more
advanced with this, we actually
can have a contract actually
deploy other contracts for us.
And then go ahead and interact
with those contracts from other
contracts, contracts interacting
with each other is an essential
part of working with solidity
and working with smart
contracts. The ability for
contracts to seamlessly interact
with each other is what's known
as composability. smart
contracts are composable,
because they can easily interact
with each other. This is
especially awesome when it comes
to things like defy where you
can have really complex
financial products interact with
each other incredibly easily,
since all their code is
available on chain. So we're
going to learn how to do that.
So let's keep our simple storage
contract exactly the way it is,
we're going to create a new
contract called storage factory.
So we're going to hit the New
File button and type in storage,
factory dot salt. And let's
close this off for now. So let's
go ahead and get this contract
setup from what we learned
before. First thing we're going
to want to do is the spdx
license identifier, which we're
going to do MIT. And then the
next thing we're always going to
need is our solidity version.
So we'll do pragma solidity
and we could do zero point 8.7.
But for this one, let's do zero
point 8.0 And then just add the
carrot, meaning any version of
0.8 point something will work.
And then let's add our contract
name, which is going to be
storage factory. Now hit command
S or ctrl S or go to the compile
tab and hit compile, and boom,
we have our regular setup here.
Now we want to create a function
that can actually deploy our
simple storage contract. So
we'll create a function called
function. create simple storage
contract, we'll have it be
public, so anybody can call it
will have to deploy a simple
storage contract and save it to
a global variable. But before we
can do it How can our storage
factory contract know what our
simple storage contract looks
like? In order to deploy it, if
our storage factory contract is
going to deploy simple storage,
it's going to need to know code
of simple storage. One way we
can do this is we can actually
go to our simple storage dot
soul and copy everything
underneath pragma, solidity and
down and paste it into our
storage factory dot soul
underneath our pragma, solidity.
If we go ahead and compile and
save this, it actually works our
storage factory, that soul
contract actually now has two
contracts in it. It has the
simple storage contract, and it
has the storage factory contract
in it, you actually go to the
deploy tab and scroll down to
deploy while you're on the
storage factory dot soul, not
the simple storage that's all on
storage factory, you can see
that you can actually choose
which one of these contracts to
deploy, a single file of
solidity can hold multiple
different contracts. Now that we
have our simple storage, that's
all in our storage factory, we
can actually go ahead and create
this function to deploy a simple
storage console, we're going to
create a global variable the
same way that we would create
any other global variable, we'll
do the type, which is going to
be type simple storage contract,
we'll give it a visibility of
public. And we'll give it a
variable name. Type simple
storage contract going to be
public, the name of the variable
is going to be simple storage.
Now in our function, create
simple storage contract, we're
gonna say simple storage equals
new, simple storage.
This new keyword is how solidity
knows Ah, okay, we're going to
deploy a new simple storage
contract. So we go ahead and
compile this, we'll go to the
deploy tab, make sure we're on
the JavaScript VM, we'll scroll
down to the contract. And we'll
choose storage factory. And
remember, you need to have
storage factory dot soul
selected. In order for that to
show up storage factory, we'll
go ahead and hit Deploy. And now
we see our storage factory
contract has two buttons. One is
create simple storage, and the
other one is going to be a view
of our simple storage contract.
If we click it right now, it's
going to show us that it's
currently at address zero,
because it gets initialized to
being blank. It's saying there
is no simple storage contract
currently deployed. Now if we
pull up our console and click
create simple storage, we see we
created a new function call
storage factory dot create
simple storage contract. And in
doing so we called this function
which created and deployed a new
simple storage contract, we can
now see what address the simple
storage contract is out by
clicking the simple storage
button and we see the address
associated with it. So now we
know how a contract can actually
deploy another contract. But the
thing is, having this massive
chunk of code above our storage
factory is a little bit
redundant, especially since we
have our other file called
Simple Storage dot soul. And
let's say we have a contract
that has got a ton of other
contracts in it. Always copy
pasting all these contracts is
going to be a lot of work. So
instead, what we can do is use
what's called an import. So
let's go ahead and delete our
contracts simple storage. And
now we're just going to type
import dot slash simple storage
dot soul. This import dot slash
simple storage dot Seoul is the
exact same as our copy pasted
version of simple storage.
That's all. It takes the path of
another file, it takes the path
package or GitHub, which we'll
get to in a minute of another
file and says, Okay, we're going
to paste that contract into the
top of this contract here, we
actually see we go back to
compile, we go to deploy, let's
delete our old contract, we can
actually see storage factory dot
soul again, we can deploy it,
click the drop down. And once
again, we can run those
functions exactly the same.
importing our contracts like
this is much nicer than always
copy pasting the code. This way,
if we want to change something
in simple storage, we have one
canonical place to go ahead and
change it instead of having to
change it in multiple different
places. Now additionally, you'll
notice the pragma, solidity if
we have our contracts in two
separate files, we actually can
have different versions of
solidity right now our storage
factory has carrot zero point
8.0 Which means that anything
within the 0.8 range of this
contract is okay. But for simple
storage that sole, it says
anything in the zero point 8.8
And above range is okay. So if
we were to try to change the
compiler version 8.5 And then go
ahead and compile, a remix is
going to automatically bump it
up to a better version that is
compatible with both of them, in
this case eight point 13. But if
we, for example, changed our
solidity version of storage
factory to zero point 7.0 And
then tried to compile them. We
actually end up getting an issue
parser error source file
requires a different compiler
version. This is because our
storage factory is saying hey,
anything in 0.7 means is okay.
However, our simple storage is
saying anything in the zero
point 8.8 And above is okay. So
those two versions are not
compatible. So what we need to
do is we need to make sure our
versions of solidity are indeed
compatible. So let's change the
version back recompile. And now
we're looking good again. Now
since we have this create simple
storage contract, every single
time we call it right now, it'll
just replace whatever is
currently in our public simple
storage variable. Let's go ahead
and update this so that we can
actually keep a running list of
all of our deployed simple
storage contracts. So instead of
having this be a single
variable, we'll make this a
simple storage array or list
public simple storage array.
Now, whenever we create a new
simple storage contract, instead
of saving it like this, what
we're going to do is we're going
to save it as a memory variable
by saying simple storage, simple
storage equals new simple
storage. And we're going to add
this variable to our simple
storage array. So the same way
we did it before, we're gonna do
simple storage array dot push,
simple storage. So I should
spell storage, right? Let's go
ahead and compile this looks
good. We'll deploy the storage
factory deploy. Like here, we
now have simple storage array
View button, we'll do create
simple storage. Now we can view
the simple storage contract
zero. Right now there's nothing
at one. But if we create another
simple storage contract, we can
see the new simple storage
contract address at index one.
All right, so this is great,
we can now keep track of all of
our simple storage deployments.
But how do we actually interact
with them, let's say we wanted
to be able to call the store
function on all of our simple
storage dot souls from our
storage factory, you can think
of the storage factory as almost
like a manager of all of our
simple storages. That's all
let's create a new function that
can do exactly that. So we'll
create function, and we'll call
it S F store, which is going to
stand for storage factory store.
And it's going to take you in
256, simple storage index, and a
UNT 256, underscore simple
storage
number. There'll be a public
auction as well. Now in order
for you to interact with any
contract, you're always going to
need two things. And we're going
to refer to this a lot. You're
always going to need the address
of the contract, and the ABI of
the contract. The API stands for
Application binary interface,
the API will tell our code
exactly how it can interact with
the contract, we'll go deeper
into API as we move on. But if
you go to your compile tab, you
hit compile, and things are
actually compiling. You can
scroll down, and you can see
compilation details. And you can
see a whole bunch of information
on your different contracts. You
can see the name of your
contract, which for our simple
storage contract is simple
storage, you can see a whole
bunch of metadata, like the
compiler, the language output
settings, all this other stuff.
You can see the exact bytecode
and the opcodes, which we'll
talk about much later. But you
can also see this API, this API
tells you all the different
inputs and outputs and
everything you could do with
this contract. For example, in
our simple storage, if we look
at the zero with index of our
API, we have a function add
person. If we look at one, we
see our name to favorite number,
we looked at two we can see our
people three retrieve for store,
it tells us all these different
ways we can actually interact
with our contract. And the
different functions that we can
call, we know where addresses
are, because we're storing them
in this array here, our simple
storage array, we can also get
the API because we're importing
simple storage dot soul when you
compile simple storage on soul.
As you saw on the compilation
details, whenever you compile
it, it comes prepackaged with
the ABI, we automatically get
the ABI just by importing it
like this. In the future, we'll
see other ways that we can
actually get API's really
easily. So to call the store
function on one of our
contracts, we're first going to
need to get that contract
object. So what we can do is we
can say simple storage variable
named simple storage. Variable
Name simple storage of type
simple storage is going to be
equal to a simple storage
object. And instead of doing new
simple storage, like we did last
time, we're just going to put
the address of this simple
storage object in here, which
again, we can get from our
array. And in this function,
we're passing the array index.
So we can say simple storage
contract at address simple
storage array. At index simple
Storage index. This bracket
notation here is how you access
different elements of arrays. So
if we want the zeroeth element
of our list here, simple storage
index would be zero, and we pass
it into this bit here, then
that'll give us the address of
our simple storage contract,
which we pass into simple
storage here. Since this is an
array of simple storage
contracts, we can just access
that simple storage contract
using the index. So we would
say, simple store, Edge array at
index underscore simple storage
index. Now we're saving the
contract object at index simple
storage index to our simple
storage variable. Our array here
is keeping track of the
addresses for us. And it
automatically comes with the ABI
is here. If this was just an
array of addresses of the
contract objects, instead, we
would have to wrap the address
in a simple storage object like
this. But we'll get to that much
later. So for now, all we have
to do is this and we now have a
simple storage contract object.
Now that we have it, we can call
our store function on the simple
storage contract. So we'll call
simple storage dot store. And
we'll store the simple storage
number to it. So this
is perfect. And if we were to
deploy this right now, though,
we wouldn't be able to read the
store function. So let's create
another function that can read
from the simple storage contract
from the storage factory. So
we'll create a function called S
F get, which stands for storage
factory get, it'll take a un 256
underscore simple storage index.
This will be a public view
function, since we're just going
to be reading from our simple
storage contract. And it's going
to return a UNT 256. And we'll
say simple storage.
Simple Storage. Equals
when you use this same syntax
from up here to get the contract
simple storage array at the
simple storage index. And then
we're going to do return,
simple storage.re retrieve
to get that number that we just
stored up here. And I should
spell retrieved correctly, so we
get no issues. Perfect. So now
we'll compile, we'll deploy JAVA
script, we're working on a fake
account, we're going to use our
storage factory, go ahead and
delete all the contracts we have
so far. Let's go ahead and
deploy the drop down rate. Right
now if we do SF get at zero,
we're going to get nothing.
Simple Storage address zero is
going to be nothing. Let's
create a simple storage
contract. Now it's simple
storage list, we get an address
at zero. If we hit SF get right
now it didn't zero, we get zero.
So let's store a value on this
contract here. So the index of
that contract is zero. So we're
going to pass zero as a symbol
storage index. And we're going
to save the number seven. So
we'll go ahead and do SF store.
And if we did this, right, this
is going to store the value
seven into this contract. So if
we do SF get of zero now, it
does indeed return seven. If we
do SF get one we're going to get
nothing's going to happen. And
we're actually going to get this
revert error here. So let's
create another simple storage
contract. Now if we do SF get
one, we get zero, because we're
gonna get that default value.
Let's go ahead on the simple
storage contract and index one
will store the number 16 will
hit SF store. Now we'll do SF
get one and we get 16. Feel free
to pause right now and play
around with this so that you
really understand it. The quick
recap is our storage factory
contract allows us to create
simple storage contracts, it
then saves it to our simple
storage array, which we can then
call different functions on, we
can store values from our
storage factory contract. And
then we can read values from our
storage factory contract for any
of the simple storage contracts
that we've created. This is
incredibly powerful, we can
additionally make these two
functions even easier. We can
call the Retrieve function
directly on this when we call
simple storage array. And then
we have these brackets and add
the simple storage index. This
returns a simple storage object.
So what we could do is we could
actually delete this whole part
and just do dot retrieve
right here, and then delete this
line and say return and just
have it be just like this. If
you go ahead and save or hit
Compile, you'll get the green
checkmark there. We're calling
the Retrieve function on
whatever this is. And whatever
this is, is a simple storage
object. So perfect. We can do
the same thing up here by
deleting this part and just
doing dot store, underscore
simple store edge number, we
save it. And this will work
exactly the same. Awesome, we
now have a simple storage
contract that can store
variables in a storage factory
contract that can be almost like
a manager of these simple
storage contracts and deploy and
interact with them themselves.
This is
fantastic. Now, let's say that
we really liked the simple
storage contract, but it doesn't
do everything that we want it to
do. Maybe we want it so that
whenever we actually store value
doesn't store the favorite
number, it stores the favorite
number plus five, for some
reason you want a contract that
that everyone's favorite number
is five numbers bigger than what
they think it is. But you really
like everything else that this
contract has to offer. Let's
create this new contract. And
we'll call it extra storage.
So we'll say extra storage dot
soul.
And we'll create this new
contract, we're going to set it
up the exact same way we
normally would spdx license
identifier, gonna be MIT, we'll
give it pragma solidity. And
we'll just do zero
point 8.0 with the carrot. And
we'll say contract, extra
storage, like so
if you save or compile, you'll
get the green checkmark. So what
can we do? Well, the first thing
we could do is we could copy
paste all this code back into
here, and then modify our extra
storage contract as we see fit.
This seems a little bit
redundant. And a lot of work
though. So what's another way we
can actually get our extra
storage contract to be like our
simple storage contract? Well,
this is where we can do
something called inheritance, we
can have our extra storage
contract, do what's called a
child contract of our simple
storage contract. And we can
have extra storage, inherit all
the functionality of simple
storage with two lines of code.
So first, in order for our extra
storage contract to know about
simple storage, we once again
need to import it. So we'll say
import dot slash, simple storage
dot soul. And we'll say our
contract extra storage is simple
storage. And we save or compile.
Now our extra storage contract
is going to be the exact same as
simple storage. And it's going
to do what's called inherit all
the functionality of simple
storage. And we can actually
even see that, let's go ahead
and make sure this is compiled.
And we'll go and deploy this.
And now in our deployed
contract, we can see we have
extra storage deployed with all
the functions that simple
storage has, if you want a
contract to inherit all the
functionality of another
contract, you can just import it
and say your contract is that
other contract. Now, we can add
additional functions to our
extra storage contract. That
will include all the
functionality of simple storage.
Now, let's say that we inherit
simple storage to extra storage.
However, one of the functions in
simple storage we don't really
actually like. So if we go back
to our simple storage contract,
our store function, all it does
is take a favorite number, and
then assigns the global favorite
number to whatever new number
that we give it in our extra
storage. We want the store
function to do something
different. We want it to add
five, to any number that we give
it. How can we achieve this?
Well, we can do something called
overriding the functions. And
there are two keywords that
we're going to use. Those are
virtual, and override. Right
now, if I were to try to
implement a store function for
extra storage, let's see what
happens. We'll say function
store, you went to the six
favorite number. There'll be a
public function. And let's say
instead of just storing favorite
number, we'll say favorite
number equals favorite number,
plus five. If we try to compile
this right now, we'll actually
run into two different errors.
First one is going to say
overriding function is missing,
override specifier. If the
parent contract, which in our
case is simple storage has that
same function, we need to tell
solidity that we're going to
override this store function and
instead we're going to use this
store function. But
additionally, we get this other
error saying trying to override
non virtual function. Did you
forget to add virtual in order
for a function to be overridable
you need to add the virtual
keyword to the store function.
Now it can be overridable.
However, if we save and compile,
we still have this issue
overriding function is missing
override specifier. And then all
we need to do is add override to
restore function. Now if we save
everything compiles correctly,
let's go ahead and deploy this.
Let's delete our old contracts.
JavaScript VM right account.
Great we're going to choose
extra store Reg, let's go ahead
and deploy. And here's our extra
storage contract. Right now if
we retrieve, we get zero.
Previously, our store function
would store the exact number.
However, if I were to store
five, it'll store five, plus
five. So we should have 10
stored here. Let's go ahead call
store looks like that one
through, and we'll hit retrieved
now. And we do indeed see 10 is
in here. So this is how we do
inheritance, and we override
functions. And that's it. For
this
section, you've just learned a
ton of incredibly powerful
solidity for having multiple
files. Let's do a quick overview
of what we learned, we learned
that we can actually deploy
contracts from other contracts
using the new keyword, we
learned that we can actually
import other contracts into our
contracts and into our code
using the Import keyword. And
the import keyword is the same
as copying pasting that file to
the location of the import line,
we learned that we can interact
with other contracts. As long as
we have the ABI and address. We
didn't learn too much about the
ABI. But we'll learn more later,
we learned that if we want to
create a child contract and
inherit the functionality of
some other contract, we can do
something called inheritance.
And the way to inherit
functionality is using the is
keyword and saying our contract
is some other contract. However,
if we want to change from the
functionality of the parent
contract, we have to override
that function. And additionally,
we have to set the function we
want to override to virtual now
we can have our own store
function, do whatever we want it
to do. That is the end of this
lesson. Once again, give
yourself a huge round of
applause a pat on the back for
making it this far. And for
finishing this section. You're
getting more and more advanced
facility so quickly, so be sure
to celebrate the little wins by
getting some ice cream, maybe
going for a walk or tweeting
about or posting on Reddit.
Congratulations, you have
completed this section.
All right, everybody. Welcome
back. We are now headed into
Lesson four remix Funmi. And of
course, all the code can be
found on the GitHub repository
associated with this course.
We're going to be working with
two contracts here, one of them
is fundament outsole. And then
one of them is price converted
outsole Funmi dot Sol is going
to be a contract that allows
people to actually fund a
collective good. So people can
send Aetherium send Aetherium,
or polygon or Avalanche or
Phantom, or whatever blockchain
native token into this contract,
and some owner of the contract
can then withdraw those funds
and do whatever they want. After
deploying this to a test net, we
can see the list of functions
this contract has, this will
have two red buttons, which are
used to notate to payable
functions in fund in our fund
function. And in our withdrawal
function, withdraw allows users
to withdraw the funding and fund
allows users to send money to
the contract, what we can do is
we can send some value along
with our transaction. When we
call this fund function, then
what we can do is we can
actually fund this contract with
a certain amount of eath, or way
by pasting some value into the
way value section. And then
hitting fund, we will now have
sent money into our deployed
contract. And we can see a list
of the funders and a mapping of
those addresses and how much
they've actually sent into the
contract, we can then withdraw
the funds out of the contract.
With a special exception with
only the person who deployed
this contract can actually
withdraw the funds back out.
Once the funds are withdrawn,
the amount of all the funds is
reset back to zero. Are you
excited? Well, you should be.
And if you've finished the
section, you've completed most
of the basics of solidity, and
you'll be ready to start making
even more powerful smart
contracts, we'll be using
channeling price feeds to
actually set the value of how
much these people should be able
to fund in USD as opposed to
just in terms of ether, we're
gonna go over a lot of advanced
sections here. And I'll let you
know what parts might be a
little bit harder to digest. So
you don't have to spend your
entire time trying to figure out
exactly what's going on. Be sure
to use the GitHub repo to your
advantage here and the
discussions tab to stay
connected with other people
taking this lesson. Alright,
let's jump in. So at this point,
in remix, you'll have a couple
of contracts here, simple
storage, storage, factory extra
storage, maybe you refreshed
remix, and these have gone away.
And in the case, make sure that
you just don't have any of those
tabs open, we're going to create
a new contract called funding.
So let's go ahead and start
creating our funding contract.
Again, we want it to be able to
get funds from users and
withdraw funds and set a minimum
funding value in USD. This is
what we're going to get our
contract to do. So first, let's
set it up spdx license I tend to
fire MIT do pragma solidity do
caret zero point 8.8. And we'll
do contract bunbee. Awesome. And
we'll compile, see if things
look good. And they do. Great.
Let's keep going. So before we
actually embark on creating all
of our functions here, let's
just add the different functions
that we're going to implement.
So we want a function fund for
people to actually send money
to, we want a function withdraw,
or the owner of this contract to
actually withdraw the funds that
different funders actually give
us. And that's pretty much it.
These are the two main functions
that we want this contract to
do, we will be implementing more
functions to help facilitate
these two functions. But let's
get started by looking at fund.
let's comment out withdrawal for
now. And let's just start with
fun. So we want anybody to be
able to call this fun function.
So we'll make this public. So as
we mentioned, we want to be able
to set a minimum font amount in
USD. So there's a lot of things
to think about here. First thing
we probably want to think about
is how do we send eath to this
contract, whenever we create a
transaction on the on any of
these EVM blockchains, there's
this value field that we can set
value represents how much
Aetherium we're going to be
sending with our transactions.
For example, when we transferred
Aetherium. between our different
accounts, we were actually
populating this value parameter
with different amounts of
Aetherium. In fact, every single
transaction that we send, will
have these fields, it'll have a
nonce or the transaction count
the account the gas price, the
gas limit that we've seen on
ether scan a to aka the address
that the transaction is sent to
a value which is going to be
this amount that we're talking
about. They'll also have data
which is going to be what we
send if we make a function call
or deploy contract, and then
we'll have this v r s
components. We're not really
going to go over these v r and s
because this is that
cryptographic magic that's
happening when a transaction is
signed, but just know that
that's it Now, for sending
value, we can populate some of
these fields, the gas limit, for
example, was populated to 21,000
data is going to be empty. And
then that two is going to be the
address of the transaction we
want to send to, for a function
call, we can also still populate
the way that we want to send. So
we can call a function and send
a value at the same time in
remix has a little drop down
here for way way Feeny and
ether, we're gonna ignore Feeny
for now. But of course, we have
our way, great and ether. Again,
we're one ether is worth this
much way. And this much way, the
first thing we need to do in
order to make a function payable
with Aetherium, or any other
native blockchain currency is we
need to mark the function as
payable. It's this payable
keyword that makes our font
function red, as opposed to
having it normal orange, just
like how our wallet can hold
funds, contract addresses can
hold funds as well, since every
time you deploy a contract, they
get a contract address, it's
nearly the exact same as a
wallet address. So both wallets
and contracts can hold native
blockchain token like Aetherium.
And you'll see that when we
deploy this later on in the
lesson, that actually will gain
a balance of Aetherium. Now that
we have it payable, we can
access this value attribute by
using one of the global keywords
in solidity with message dot
value to get how much value
somebody is sending. You use
message dot value in your
function. Now let's say we want
to set our message add value to
a certain value of Aetherium.
Let's say we wanted it to be
let's say we wanted people to
send at least one whole ether
with all the transactions. Or
put another way, if they sent
Aetherium, they would need to
send at least one Aetherium. How
would we implement that? Well,
we could do something called
require, we would say we want to
require the message dot value is
greater than one e 18. There's a
couple of things to unpack here.
One, e 18 is equal to one times
10 raised to the 18th, which is
also equal to
112345 678-910-1234 5678. This
is the value in way of one
Aetherium this much way is one
eath. So if we wanted the
message dot value to be at least
one eath, or one polygon or
whatever ranch etc, we would set
it like this require message on
value is greater than one. This
require keyword is a checker it
says hey, is message dot value
greater than one. If not, it's
going to revert, it's going to
do what's called revert with an
error message. And we can say
didn't send enough, we're gonna
try deploying this on a
JavaScript VM, deploy Funmi,
we'll hit Deploy, look at Funmi
we see this fun button is now
red. If we call Funmi right now,
and we look at the console, you
can see we actually get an error
here, call it again, we get an
error, we get an error here, we
know that the air is going to be
this didn't send enough. So what
we need to do is we need to send
at least one ether with this fun
transaction, in order for this
require statement to be
fulfilled. So back up in the
value section, we can change
this value to one. So that's
gonna be one ether, or this much
way or this much way. Now we can
hit fund oh actually needs to be
greater than one.
So let's send to for example.
Now we'll scroll down. And now
we'll hit fund. And we see that
that actually passes the require
statement says if our first
section is false, then go ahead
and revert with this error. What
is reverting? Revert can be a
little bit confusing, so I
wouldn't let this section hold
you back. If it's a little bit
confusing. Revert is when it
undos any actions that happened
before and send the remaining
gas back. So what does that
actually look like? Well, let's
say for example, we had a un
256. Public number. And in our
fund function, we said number
equals five. If we were to go
ahead and deploy this, let's
delete our old contract.
deployed this new contract or
number right now is zero. But if
we were to call our fund
function number gets set to
five. However, if we call a fund
and this require isn't met, this
transaction would revert an
undue setting number to five. So
let's go ahead and look at our
logs here. We'll keep value zero
so that our fun function
reverts. We'll call fund will
see that this transaction failed
because this require end up
reverting and number is still
zero. So then the question
becomes, did we actually spend
gas Yes, we spent gas to change
number to five and then any
remaining gas we would get
returned by this require for
example, if we had a ton of
computation here, it On a
computation here, we would have
need to send a ton of gas with
our fun function. But all the
extra gas that we send, after
this require gets returned the
original user after it gets
reverted right here, if reverts
are a little bit confusing for
you here, don't worry too much
about it, we'll go over it in
future modules. All you need to
know right now is that when you
do a require statement, if this
first section isn't met, the
transaction will be canceled,
and any prior work will be
undone, and it'll send an error
message. Cool. Let's delete this
number for now. And we'll delete
it from the global scope.
There's actually another way to
do these reverts, which we'll go
over
later in this contract. So what
we've done so far is great.
However, we're checking message
dot value in terms of Aetherium,
we're looking for one whole
Aetherium instead of $50, we
want to check that message add
value is greater than some
number like $50. Let's go ahead
and first set the minimum USD
value we want people to send
along with the fund function, we
can do that at the top of our
contract, we can say you went to
56 public minimum USD equals 50.
Now we have some place to check
for minimum USD, we're going to
update this minimum USD to make
it more gas efficient and a
little bit. Now that we've set
our minimum USD, we want to be
able to require the message that
value is greater than or let's
say greater than or equal to the
minimum USD. But minimum USD is
in terms of USD and value is in
terms of Aetherium. So how do we
convert Aetherium to USD, this
is where Oracle's and chainlink
are going to come into play. The
USD value of Aetherium is
something that we've assigned
outside of the blockchain to
Aetherium, or any other layer
one currency or any other native
smart contract platform
currency. So in order to get
this value that is outside the
blockchain, we have to use a
decentralized Oracle network to
get the price of one ether in
terms of USD. So before we can
continue on here, let's learn a
little bit more about the
architecture of these
decentralized Oracle networks
and the different solutions that
they have. So that we can create
this Funmi contract in the most
advanced way possible, as we've
talked about blockchains are
deterministic systems, which
means that they themselves can't
actually interact with real
world data and events. They
don't know what the value of an
Aetherium is, they don't know
what random numbers are. They
don't know if it's sunny
outside, they don't know the
temperature, they don't know
who's president, they don't know
any of this information. These
blockchains also can't do any
external computation. Maybe you
have some amazing artificial
intelligence model that you want
to integrate with a smart
contract. smart contracts by
themselves can't do anything
with that. As we've mentioned,
this is because blockchains are
deterministic by design. This is
so that all the nodes can reach
consensus. If you start adding
variable data or random data, or
values that returned from an API
call, different nodes could get
different results, and they
would never be able to reach a
consensus. This is known as the
smart contract connectivity
problem, or the Oracle problem.
And this is bad news, because we
want our smart contracts to be
able to replace traditional
agreements. And traditional
agreements need data and they
need to interact with the real
world. So this is where
chainlink and blockchain,
Oracle's come into place. A
blockchain Oracle is going to be
any device that interacts with
the often world to provide
external data or computation to
smart contracts. However, the
whole story doesn't even in
there. If we use a centralized
Oracle, we are reintroducing a
point of failure. We've done all
this work to make our logic
layer decentralized. But if we
get our data through a
centralized node or through a
centralized API, we decide we
want to make the API call
ourselves. We are reintroducing
these trust assumptions that
we've worked so hard to get rid
of, we're essentially ruining
the entire purpose of building a
smart contract. So we don't want
to get our data or do external
computation through centralized
nodes. Those are bad news. chain
link is the solution here. chain
link is a decentralized Oracle
network for bringing data and
external computation into our
smart contracts. As we mentioned
before, this gives rise to these
hybrid smart contracts, which
combined on chain and off chain
to make incredibly feature rich,
powerful applications. chain
link is a modular, decentralized
Oracle network that can be
customized to deliver any data
or do any external computation
that you like. So for example, a
lot of people say, Oh, I can
just make an HTTPS call to some
API, and we'll be good to go.
The blockchain nodes can't make
these HTTPS calls, because they
wouldn't be able to reach
consensus. If they called the
node at different times, or they
did something else. All the
consensus would be broken. So
instead, we need a decentralized
network of chain link Oracle's
to do this, and then in the
transaction, this network of
nodes will work Turn the data to
our smart contracts for us. Now
chainlink networks can be
completely customized to bring
any data or any external
computation that you want.
However, doing the customization
can be a little bit extra work,
there are a ton of chainlink
features that come out of the
box completely decentralized,
ready to plug and play into your
smart contract applications.
What are those features, the
first one is going to be
channeling data feeds, and
that's the one we're actually
going to be using for
application here. Channeling
data feeds currently at the time
of recording are powering over
$50 billion. In the defy world,
the way they work is a network
of chain link nodes gets data
from different exchanges and
data providers and brings that
data through a network of
decentralized chain like notes,
the chain link nodes use a
median to figure out what the
actual price of the asset is,
and then deliver that in a
single transaction to what's
called a reference contract, a
price feed contract or a data
contract on chain that other
smart contracts can use. And
then those smart contracts use
that pricing information to
power their defy application, we
can see an example. We can see
an example at data dot chain dot
link. And you can change
networks, you can change price
feeds, you can change a whole
bunch of different information
to see some of those popular
price feeds. Let's look at eath
USD for example. On eath USD, we
can see this whole network of
independent chain link node
operators that are each getting
different answers for the price
of eth USD, they're getting
aggregated by the network and
then delivered on chain, we can
see how often they're updated.
These ones are updated 4.5
deviation threshold or a few
hour heartbeat, whichever one
hits. First, we can see when the
last update was we can see the
number of Oracle responses etc,
we can see the contract address
directly on chain, we can even
look at the contract on ether
scan, we can see some of the
history, we can see all the
responses of the different
Oracle's. And then at the
bottom, we can see the different
users and sponsors, keeping this
network up. Similar to
transaction gas, whenever a node
operator delivers data to a
smart contract, the chain link
node operators are paid a little
bit of Oracle gas in the chain
link token. Right now these
users of the protocol are
sponsoring keeping these feeds
up and are paying the Oracle gas
associated with delivering this
data on chain. Here's an
illustration of what the current
model of these data feeds look
like a network of these chain
link nodes, each reaches out and
gets the information about an
asset and then signs the data
with their own private key in a
single transaction, then, one
node will deliver all the data
with all the different
signatures to a reference
contract. If that node doesn't
deliver the data, another node
will send it instead. Reputation
is incredibly important when
your chain link node operator if
you miss data updates, if you
forget to send transactions,
you'll probably be quickly
kicked off these networks and
have no chance of making any
more money in the future. These
data feeds are used by some of
the largest protocols in the
space, such as synthetics, sushi
swap compound, and Avi, with
several billion dollars each, we
can take a look at an example
over at Doc's dot chain dot link
work with EVM contracts, we're
going to hit EVM chains, scroll
down to data feeds. We'll scroll
down to the solidity section.
And we can see an example of an
entire contract that uses and
reads from one of these trending
price feeds. We can even open
this up and remix and work with
it and remix. It looks like this
example is reading from a price
feed on COVID. The reason we're
actually going to use a test net
to see this work is that there's
a set of chain link nodes
monitoring the test network.
Just to show you exactly how
this works out. Once we get
deeper into the course, we'll
show you how to actually run
tests and work with chain link
nodes without actually being on
a test net, which will make your
development much faster. But I
highly recommend walking through
this section along with me so
that you can see firsthand how
this actually works. So let's go
ahead and faucets dot chain dot
link slash COVID. We're going to
switch to the COVID network,
we're going to get some COVID
eath. But remember, look at the
network flag and use whatever
network is in the documentation.
So to get some COVID, we're
going to come to the faucet,
we're going to turn off test
link, we'll just stay with eath
I'm not a robot,
and then send request. Once our
COVID Aetherium has reached our
wallet, we can go ahead and
close we can take a look in our
wallet and see that we do indeed
have 0.1 eath on Kelvin. Now
let's go back to our remix,
we'll compile this contract, go
and deploy this on injected web
three. And again, the reason
we're going to use injected web
three instead of JavaScript VM
is that there's no network of
chain link nodes watching our
little fake JavaScript VM. There
are a network of chain link
nodes watching the test net. So
we'll scroll down. We'll switch
contract to the price consumer V
three, and we'll hit Deploy and
a mass will pop up and after a
brief delay, we can see our
price feed consumer down here
and we can hit Get the latest
price which shows us the latest
price of Aetherium in terms of
USD you may be wondering why the
number looks so weird. That
seems like a really large number
for the price of Aetherium in
terms of USD, and this is
because decimals don't actually
work so well in solidity, and
we'll get to that in a little
bit. There's a decimals flag
associated with this price feed
address, that tells us how many
decimals to include with this
price. It's also in the
documentation. However, I know
that this one has eight
decimals. So this is saying the
value of Aetherium right now is
$3,262. It may of course be
different when you go ahead and
try this. Now there's a number
of things that happened in this
contract that I'll explain in
our Funmi example. But if you
want to take a look now and see
if you can figure out what's
going on, I recommend you do so.
Price feeds are one of the most
powerful out of the box
decentralized features, you can
use your smart contract to level
them up, especially for
decentralized finance. If you're
looking for different addresses
of different price feeds, you
can check the contract addresses
section of the documentation,
choose the network that you
want, and then scroll down and
look some of the different
addresses of the different price
feeds. For example, this address
will give you the price of one
inch token in terms of
Aetherium. This address will
give you the price of the Apple
stock in terms of USD, and so on
and so forth. The next
decentralized application right
out of the box is going to be
channeling VRF or channeling
verifiable random dysfunction.
Once we do our lottery example a
little bit later, we'll talk
about how randomness can be
manipulated in blockchain.
blockchains are deterministic
systems, which by definition
means that they can't have
randomness. If you can determine
what a random number is, it's
not really random anymore, is
it? So we need to wait to get a
provably random number by
looking outside of the
blockchain and Oracle's are
perfectly positioned to do
exactly that. chainlink
verifiable randomness function
is a way to get provably a
random number into our smart
contract to guarantee fairness
and guarantee randomness of
applications. Many protocols
like pool together x infinity,
ether cards, avocado cheese and
more use channeling VRF for
lotteries, randomizing NF T's
for gaming and for more, we're
going to do an example of
channeling VRF in a later
section. Once we get to the
lottery section, if you want to
see if you can play with the
randomness yourself right now, I
recommend you go into Doc's
chain link EVM chains, and
scroll down to get a random
number. And this will teach you
how to get a provably random
number into your applications.
The next decentralized out of
the box feature of chain link is
chain like keepers, which is
decentralized event driven
execution. As we've seen, in
order to kick off some type of
transaction, somebody needs to
spend the gas and somebody needs
to sit down and hit the go
button or hit the transact
button or hit the sun. But this
is obviously a centralized
vector. If you have a
decentralized application that
needs to run at specific times,
or after specific events are
triggered. Channeling keepers
are the solution to this
channeling keepers are chain
link nodes that listen to a
registration contract for
different events that you
specify to fire. Maybe you say
every 10 minutes, you want to do
something or once a week do
something or if the price of
some acid hits some number, or
maybe a liquidity pool is at a
certain level, whatever event
that you want to code, you
absolutely can the chain link
nodes constantly listen for
these triggers to happen and
check the different contracts
for these triggers. Once a
trigger returns true, the chain
link nodes will then perform
whatever action that you tell
the chain link nodes to do,
we're also not going to go over
the chain link keepers examples
right now, because we're going
to get to them in a later
module. However, if you want to
try them out, go to Doc's
touching that link slash
Aetherium. Going and go to
making compatible contracts and
feel free to read the
documentation. Try it out
yourself. The last out of the
box feature of chain link is the
most customizable, but also the
hardest to get correct end to
end reliability is the ultimate
promise of our smart contracts.
And we want and need them to be
able to do anything, we want to
be able to take any input and
get any output making HTTP GET
HTTP POST request is an easy way
to customize our chain link
nodes to be able to do anything.
Remember how we talked about
making API calls that blockchain
nodes themselves can do that?
Well, chain link nodes can do
that chain link nodes can make
direct requests to any API that
you specify. In order to do
this, you both have to choose
the chain link node and the URL
slash data to send the request
to this is a little bit trickier
than chain link VRF keepers or
price feeds because you then
have to be responsible for
creating the chain link network
that gets data from many
different chain link nodes and
many different data providers.
But let's look at an example in
remix anyways. For this section,
feel free to just watch it since
we are working with a test net
here. And test nets, as we've
seen, can take a little bit of
time. As long as you're familiar
with what this process looks
like. That's good enough. You
don't actually have to try it if
you don't want to. So we'll open
up and remix will read through.
It looks like this example is on
the COVID network. So we'll go
ahead and compile API consumer.
We're gonna go ahead and deploy
on the injected web three, we're
going to make sure that we're
back on the COVID test network.
We're going to scroll down. And
we're going to change the
contract to the API consumer.
And we're going to go ahead and
hit Deploy, we're going to
deploy this contract to the
COVID. Test net. And now we can
call this function called
Request volume data to actually
make an API call. Now, like I
mentioned before, whenever we
request data from a chain link
node, we have to pay a little
bit of Oracle gas, or link
token, in order to pay some link
token, we're going to need to
have link token in our API
consumer contract. This is
what's known as the basic
request and receive model to get
link token, we go back to our
faucet, and this time, we'll
select 10 test link for our
contract. Let's go ahead and
verify that we're human. And
we'll hit Send Request. This
time, instead of sending us
Aetherium. They're sending us 10
test link, which is what's known
as an ERC 20 token. Or more
accurately, in ERC 677 We'll get
to understanding that a little
bit later, we can see the asset
in our Metamask. By importing
the token, in order to get the
token, we're going to come back
to the documentation. And we're
going to look up link token
contracts like that, we're going
to go to the network that we
just got the tokens on, which
for us was COVID. We're going to
copy this address, we're gonna
go to Metamask, hit import
tokens, paste that address, and
hit add custom token, and then
import tokens. And now we can
see in our account one, we both
have Aetherium and 10. Link, now
that we have our link or Oracle
gas, we're going to send it to
our API consumer, we're going to
copy the address of the API
consumer, open up our meta mask,
we're gonna hit send, paste the
address of our contract, switch
the asset to link. For now we'll
just send 0.2 link. We'll hit
next, next. And we'll hit
Confirm. And we'll wait for this
transaction to go through. I
chose 0.2 Link, because in this
contract, there's a fee
character, which tells us how
much making an API call for this
is going to cost. This one is
actually 0.1 link, I send 0.2.
Just in case, we want to make
that API call twice. Everything
that's going on in this function
will explain in a little bit
later section. But for now, I
just want to show you what it
looks like to do is, once we
send the link to our contract,
we can first check to see what
the volume is volume is zero, we
want to get the volume of the
last 24 hours of Aetherium
asset, we're going to be calling
this API which has a ton of raw
data, including one in specific
called volume over the last 24
hours, which can be this number
right here. Say we wanted to get
this into our contract from this
API, we're going to make an HTTP
GET call to this API. And what's
going to happen is we're going
to make the request in one
transaction. And in a second
transaction, the chain link node
is gonna return the value and
store it in this volume variable
in the global scope. So let's go
ahead and hit request volume
data Metamask gonna pop up,
we're going to go ahead and hit
Confirm. And you'll notice right
away volume doesn't update. This
is again, because we actually
need to wait two transactions,
we're sending a transaction for
the request. And then in a
second transaction, the chain
link node is actually going to
respond. And after a slight
delay, the chain link node has
indeed responded with the result
of making that API call back to
our contract. We'll go over this
process a little bit more in
depth in later sections. The
reason that I wanted to show you
specifically the API calls, is
because we're going to show you
a real life example of how to
use chain link VRF and chain the
keepers in a later lesson.
Now I know we've already gone
over a ton. So let's do a quick
review. In order to send
Aetherium or whatever native
blockchain token with a function
need to mark it as payable. If
you need something in your
contract to happen, and you want
the whole transaction to fail.
If that doesn't happen, you can
use a require statement. To get
the Aetherium or native
blockchain token value of a
transaction, you can use the
global keyword message dot
value. chain link is a
technology for getting external
data and doing external
computation in a decentralized
context for our smart contracts.
Channeling data feeds or price
feeds are ways to read pricing
information or other pieces of
data from the real world that's
already aggregated and
decentralized for us, channeling
VRF is a way to get provably
random numbers from the real
world into our smart contracts.
Channeling keepers are a way to
do decentralized event driven
computation. We can set some
trigger say if this trigger hits
do something and we get to
define what the trigger is and
what to do something is
channeling any API's is the
ultimate customization of
channeling nodes and allows us
to connect to anything on the
planet. To make this one
production ready. We have to do
the most work because it doesn't
come already with a
decentralized Oracle network,
like chaining the keepers and
price feeds. We'll learn more
about these channeling services
as we continue in this course.
Now in order for us to figure
out if our message dot value is
actually greater than the
minimum USD that we set, we
actually have to convert our
message dot value from its layer
one slash Aetherium to the USD
equivalent. So how are we
actually going to do that? Well,
first, we're gonna need to get
the price of Aetherium, or
Phantom, or Avalanche or
whatever layer, one blockchain
that we're working with. So
let's create a function to get
that price to get that
conversion rate. So we'll do
function, get price, and this is
going to be the function that we
use to get the price of the room
in terms of USD, so we can
convert our message dot value to
USD. And then we're also going
to do a function called Get
conversion rate. These are both
going to be public functions, so
that we can go ahead and call
them and test them and do
whatever we want with them. So
in order to get the price, we're
going to have to use one of
these chain link data feeds to
get the pricing information. And
we can look right here at this
contract to see what using one
of these channeling price feeds
looks like. What we're actually
doing when we're interacting
with this channeling price feed
is we're actually reading from
one of these contracts, there's
a contract out there called the
aggregator contract that has a
function called latest round
data, which returns a whole
bunch of data. But namely, this
int price. And this in price is
what we are interested in. Let's
look at our get price function
and figure out how do we
actually call this since this is
an instance of us interacting
with a contract outside of our
project, we're going to need two
things. What are those two
things,
we're going to need the ABI of
the contract, and also the
address of the contract. So the
address of the contract is going
to be easy, we can get the
address of the contract from the
contract address this section of
the chain link data feeds. Let's
scroll on down to bank B. And we
can find the eath USD address on
Rigby and we'll create this
contract so that it works on
Rinkeby. So we're going to grab
this address, we're going to
copy it. And we're going to move
back to our to our code here.
And we're going to paste the
address here. So great, we have
the address. Now we have the
address of the other contract
that we don't want to interact.
Now, how do we get the ABI?
Well, what we did before was
simple storage was we imported
the entire contract into our
code here. That's something that
we could do. But that's actually
a lot of code. So what's
something that we could do
instead, remember, if we're
looking at remix, and we look at
one of the contracts that we
compiled before, the ABI is
really just kind of this list of
the different functions and
interactions you can have with a
contract. The ABI itself doesn't
actually need to include any of
the logic, it just needs to
include, hey, here are the
different functions that you can
call, for example, in this
contract, we can call fund, we
have get conversion rate, we
have get price, they're not
implemented yet, but they will
be eventually now there
technically is another way to
interact with contracts without
the API. But for now, we're just
going to ignore that. So how can
we get the API, there's a
concept in solidity called an
interface. And let's look at an
example of an interface. If we
go to github.com/smart, contract
kits, chainlink, we can see a
number of different contracts in
the chainlink repository, we can
go to contracts, src, V 0.8,
interfaces, and we'll go to
aggregator v3 interface, dot
soul. And if we look at the
solidity in here, we can see a
whole bunch of function
declarations, but none of the
logic is actually implemented in
this. This is what's known as an
interface. If we compile this,
we'll actually get the ABI of a
contract, because it defines all
the different ways we can
interact with the contract. It
doesn't actually say, what these
functions do, which is fine,
though, because we don't need to
know what the functions actually
do, those are going to be stored
in the contract. So what we can
do is we can grab this interface
from the code and paste it into
our remix. Now hold on, if
you're following along, you
don't have to copy paste this
with me, because I'm going to
show you an easier way in just a
second. So for now, feel free to
go ahead and just watch. But
once we have this interface
aggregator v3 interface, we can
now use this to make API calls.
So now we could say, aggregator
v3 interface at this address.
And the combination of these
two, give us that aggregator v3
contract with whatever code is
here. If at this contract
address is aggregator v3
interfaces valid, we can do
something like dot version.
Let's look at this interface. Is
there a version function? There
sure is. So that means we can
call the version function on
this contract. So let's actually
go ahead and copy this into a
different section. I'm going to
create a new function called Get
version just to illustrate this.
I'm going to be public. It's
going to be a view and it's
going to return the UN 256 and
We're gonna split it up into two
steps here. We're gonna say
aggregate tour, v3 interface,
price feed. So we're creating a
variable of type aggregator v3
interface equals aggregator v3
interface at this address. And
then we're going to return price
feed that version. Now I'm going
to go ahead and deploy this
contract to Rigby just to show
you what this git version is
going to return. But you don't
have to follow along here if you
don't want because again, we're
working with the test net, you
can just watch if you'd like for
this section, we're going to
test a little bit more sparse.
Since we're going to be mainly
using the test net, since we're
going to be working with an
actual chain link Oracle
network, once you move over to
hard hat, and with JavaScript,
all this testing locally will be
a lot easier and a lot faster,
you're more than welcome to go
ahead and fiddle and try and
test a lot of this stuff as we
go along. But just know that it
might take a little bit longer
to do some of the testing on the
test net,
let's delete that last funding
contract, we're going to deploy
this one, we're going to scroll
up, we're going to switch to
injected web three, we're going
to switch from COVID to rink B.
And the reason we want to make
sure we're on rink beam is
because this address is specific
to rink B, the contract that
we're looking to interact with
might not be at this address on
every single chain, we want to
make sure we're on the rink B
chain for this, because of some
other contract is there on the
different chain, this version
function obviously won't exist,
and this function could error.
So let's go ahead, we're gonna
find me, we're going to deploy
this to the rink V chain. Again,
you don't have to follow along
with me here, you can just
watch. And once that contract
has been deployed, we now have a
view function called Get
version. And we can see it's
returning the variable for
showing us that this is the
fourth version of a price feed.
So this is a really easy way for
us to interact with contracts
that exist. Outside of our
project, we use one of these
interfaces, which can get
compiled down to the API, and
then combine that ABI with the
address to call a function. As
we work with these interfaces
more and more, they'll start to
make more and more sense. So if
it's a little confusing to you
right now, don't get
discouraged, the more you work
with it, the easier it will
become. Now, though, now that we
know how to call these functions
in here, we can start working
with this interface. However, as
you know, if we have a whole
bunch of interfaces, we're gonna
have to stick a whole bunch of
interfaces at the top of our
code, which looks pretty ugly.
What's a better way for us to do
this? Well, before we used
import, right, we imported from
simple storage. That's all for
this one, what we could do is we
could import from an array gay
Tore v3 interface. That's all,
we can go ahead and create a new
contract with this aggregator v3
interface. Or what we can do is
we can import this directly from
GitHub. If we go back to the
documentation of these chainlink
data feeds go to using data
feeds, we scroll down, we see at
the top, we have this import
statement, import at chain link
slash contracts slash SFC visa
right interfaces aggregator v3
interface, this, this import is
has the same path setup as the
GitHub repository for the chain
link code, instead of us
directly adding all the code
right into our remix, what we
can do instead is we can import
directly from GitHub, or what's
called an NPM package. Remix is
smart enough to know that at
chain link slash contracts, is
referring to the NPM package at
chain link slash contracts,
we'll talk about NPM, a little
bit in the future, it's what's
known as a package manager, and
can keep versions of different
contracts for us to directly
import into our code bases at
chain link slash contracts is
created directly from the
chainlink GitHub repository. So
remix downloads this code from
NPM, which is created from this
GitHub. So now we know that if
we import at chain link slash
contracts, src, V 0.8 interfaces
aggregator v3 interface dot
soul, this is the same as if we
had just stuck this whole
contract right at the top of our
funding contract, which makes
our code look a lot nicer. And
now we have this aggregator v3
interface that we can work with.
Okay, great. So now that we have
a minimalistic interface, which
will give us the API, how do we
actually go ahead and get the
price here? Well, documentation
has a good example, if you want
to play with it and try to
reverse engineer it as well.
Here's how we're going to do it.
In our code. We're going to
create an aggregator v3
interface object called price
feed an aggregator v3 variable
called price feed, which is
going to equal to aggregator v3
interface contract at address
this address exactly the same as
what we're doing down here.
We're assuming a contract at
this address is going to have
all the functionality of this
aggregator v3 interface, which
again, means it has this
decimals function, this
description function version,
get round data. And the
important one latest round data,
which has the latest price at
this answer piece, what we can
do now is we can call that
latest round data function on
the price feed. So we'll say
price feed dot latest round
data. Now if we look at the
interface, we see that this
latest round data actually
doesn't return one variable, it
returns a whole bunch of
different variables. And that's
what we're going to return in
our contract. So we're going to
put these parentheses, and we're
going to say, you went at round
ID, we can even look right at
the documentation to see what
else it returns int price, you
went,
you went started out, you went
timestamp. And then you went ad,
answered and round. Now there's
a lot of code here. Since this
function returns so many
different variables, we have to
set something up to capture
them. However, all we care about
is price. We don't care about
round Id started at timestamp or
answered in round. So what we
can do is just remove them and
just leave the commas.
Now we have int price equals
price feed that latest round
data. The reason that price is
an int 256. And not a un 256 is
because some prices or some data
feeds could be negative here, so
that it's an int 256. So it can
stay flexible. Now that we have
the price, this is going to be
price of eath in terms of USD.
And we saw an example of this
before, it was around 3000. And
it returned this number because
solidity doesn't work with
decimals for a number of
reasons. But we just need to
know that there are eight
decimal places associated with
this price feed. If you want to
double check how many decimals
there are, this contract has a
decimal function that you can
call as well, that will tell you
exactly how many decimals are in
this price feed. Now as we know,
message dot value is going to
have 18 decimal places. Why does
it have 18 decimal places? Well,
because one ether is equal to
1-234-567-8910 12345678 Is this
massive number in way which has
18 zeros, which is equivalent to
1.12345 678-910-1234 5678. So we
want these to have the same
decimal places, right? Because
right now this has eight, this
is 18. They're different units
right now. So to get them to
match up, all we need to do is
return price times one, ie 10,
or one raised to the 10th, which
is equal to 1123456789 10.
Message dot value, though, is
going to be a UNT 256. And right
now, price is an interval at
six. So why did we convert this
value from n into 56. To a human
to 56? Well, we can do what's
called typecasting, all we need
to do is add you into 56. And
wrap this whole thing up between
these two parentheses, you can't
typecast anything. But there are
some values like into 56 and you
into 56, that can be easily
converted between the two. Now
of course, since we're not
modifying any state with this
get price function, we can make
this view and say it returns
that you went to 36. And if we
save and compile, we go ahead
and we get that checkmark. Now
math can be a little bit tricky.
The first couple times you do it
in solidity. But the more you do
it, the easier it becomes. And
in the future, we can always
reference a function like this
to figure out okay, here's the
easiest way for me to get this
number. Awesome. So now we have
a get price function, which is
going to return a un 256, which
is going to be the price of
Aetherium. In terms of USD, all
we need to do is convert the
message dot value from
Aetherium. To terms of dollars,
let's create this get conversion
rate function. So this one,
we're going to take an input
parameter of un 256 of eath
amount, it's going to be a
public view function. And it's
going to return you went to 56,
we're going to pass it some eath
amount. And on the other side,
we're going to get how much that
eath is worth in terms of USD.
So we're going to do a u
intuity. Six eath price equals
get price. So first, we're going
to call our get price function
that we just created to get the
price of Aetherium. Then we're
going to do u and 256 eath
amount in USD equals eath price
times eath amount, and then
we're going to divide it by 118.
When you're doing multiplication
and division math in solidity,
you always want to multiply and
add first and then go ahead and
divide since eath price and eath
amount both have 18 additional
decimal places if we were to
just let them rock without this,
they would have an additional 36
zeros tax tacked onto the end.
So we need to divide by one EA
team. Now when we get to the
hard hat sections of this course
testing all this math is going
to be a lot easier. And if
you're really struggling with
some of the math bits right now,
I wouldn't let that slow you
down. Because once we get to
heart, it's going to become a
lot easier to actually test this
than working on a test net. And
this eath amount in terms of USD
is the number that we're looking
for. So we can just go ahead and
return eath amount in USD, CSB
returns here, and boom, now we
have a good conversion rate
function to walk you through the
math real quick. Let's say the
eath price is going to be
$3,000. So it's going to be
3000. But it's going to have an
additional 18 zeros tacked on
the end, it matches the message
dot value way units. And let's
say for example, we send one
eath or 112345 678-910-1234 5678
eath into this contract, one
eath should equal $3,000. So to
get the price, we're going to
now do the eath price, which is
3000 times the eath amount,
which is this one, and then
divide by one raised to the
18th. So method out we'll do
3123 1-234-567-8910 12345678
times we'd
1001 2345678 1-234-567-8910
times 112345678 1-234-567-8910.
And now we divide that by
112345678 1-234-567-8910, which
equals 2.9. Mmm, II 21, which
the calculator kind of messed up
them a little bit, but 2.9, not
2.99, ie 21 means this has 21
decimal places. So it'd be
2.1 234-567-8910 1-234-567-8910
one, or
1-234-567-8910 12345678 2900 I
9.99 and a nine. And this is
actually exactly the reason why
we don't do decimal math in
solidity, our calculator saw
that massive number was having a
hard time getting it. So it
ended up rounding that number to
2.999. And nine, when we work
exclusively with whole numbers
in solidity, we don't have a
chance of losing that precision.
And in solidity, this is going
to return exactly $3,000, which
is correct one Aetherium at
$3,000 per Aetherium is going to
be $3,000. And like I said,
since we're building this
contract, assuming we're going
to be working on this test net,
we're not going to test this
function on the test net,
because we're going to have to
wait for that transaction to go
through. If you want to go ahead
and deploy this and play around
with it yourself, you're more
than welcome to Okay, great, now
we have a function called Get
conversion rate that we can use
on our fund function to make
sure we've sent enough message
dot value in our fund. So what
we can do now is all we need to
do is to get conversion rate of
message dot value needs to be
greater than the minimum USD. Of
course, right now our minimum
USD is just in terms of 50. And
we know that conversion rate is
going to return it with 18 zeros
to represent the decimal places,
our minimum USD amount needs to
be upgraded to 10 to 50 times
one e 18. Or again, one times
10, raise the 18th, I'm going to
deploy this to a test net just
to demonstrate it. But again,
you don't have to if you don't
want to wait for this. So I'm
gonna go ahead and deploy this
confirm. And now we have this
funny contract. If I don't say
anything in value, and hit the
fun button, we're gonna get this
gas estimation error failed.
This is kind of a blanket error,
basically saying, Hey, you can
go ahead and send this
transaction if you want, it's
highly likely that it's not
going to work. And the reason
that remix knows that it's
probably not going to work is
because it can see this require
and simulate the transaction and
say, Hey, you didn't send enough
money with this. However, even
if we send some money, like 5000
way, it'll still give us this
error. Because that's not
enough. Let's do the calculation
right now based on what the
price of eath is. So we can
actually go to data dot chain
that link, we look and see
approximately what the price is.
So it looks like the price of
Aetherium right now is about
$3,000. And this might be
different for you depending on
when you do that. So if the
price of Aetherium is $3,000,
and our minimum is at least 50.
We could do 50 divided by
3000 0.016 eath should be
approximately enough. So if we
go to our Aetherium converter,
and we do 0.016, we'll get how
much that is in way, let's do
0.02 Just to make sure that
we're going to be over the
amount. So we'll paste that in.
We'll change this to way. And
now if I hit the fun button,
instead of us getting that error
popping up, it's going to
actually go ahead and let us do
the fun function and we could
confirm it and it wouldn't fail.
I'm going to reject it for now
just because I don't really feel
like waiting for the transaction
to go through. But great. We've
confirmed that our get
conversion rate is one working
as intended, awesome, great
work.
So what's the next bit of this
funding contract that we want to
do? Well, when people actually
send money to this contract, we
want to keep track of all the
people who send us money. So
let's create some data
structures. To keep track. Let's
create an array of addresses
called funders. And we'll keep
adding all the funders who send
money to us. So we'll say an
address array, or an address
list. We'll make it public
funders. And anytime somebody
sends us money, and this
actually does indeed go through,
we'll add that funded server
list. So we'll say funders dot
push message dot sender, like
message dot value. Message dot
sender is an always available
global keyword message dot value
stands for how much Aetherium or
how much native blockchain
currency is sent. Message dot
sender is the address of whoever
calls the font function. So if
we're on Rigby message dot
sender is going to be equal to
whatever address is calling that
function. Since our address is
sending the ether, we're going
to add our address to this
funders list. This way we can
keep track of all the wonderful
donators who are donating to our
contract, then maybe we won't
even make a mapping of addresses
to you and 250 sixes of
addresses to how much money each
one of these people have
actually sent. So we'll do
address to you and 256 public
address to amount funded. And
when somebody funds our contract
will say address to amount
funded of message dot sender
equals message dot value. Now we
have a function where people can
fund our contract. And we can
set a value in terms of USD and
we keep track of the different
funders who actually fund our
contract. This is fantastic. Now
I know we've gone over a lot of
really intense math and intense
stuff here. So so let's do a
quick refresher of what we've
learned so far. Whenever we work
with a contract, we always need
the API and the address when
compiled an interface gives us
that minimalistic API to
interact with contracts outside
of our project. When you combine
these compiled interfaces with
an address, we can call the
functions on that interface on
that contract. chain link. data
feeds are a decentralized way to
get information about the real
world. In this case, we're
getting the price of Aetherium
in terms of USD from a
decentralized collective of
chain link nodes. When working
with math and solidity. Decimals
don't work. So we need to keep
that in mind when doing any type
of math in solidity. And we need
to make sure we always have the
correct units, so that our math
makes sense. Message dot value,
and message dot sender, our
globally available variables
were message dot sender
represents the sender of the
message or transaction. And
message dot value represents the
number of ways sent with the
message. There's a whole bunch
of different special variables
and functions that we can access
at any time. And these are
available in the solidity
documentation. Alright, great,
we've got a great way that we
can actually start funding our
contract. But our code looks a
little bit messy, we've got a
couple of different functions
for getting the price and
working with these prices, is
there a way to make this math a
lot easier to use, this is where
we're going to introduce the
concept of a library. So what is
a library, I definitely
recommend checking out solidity
by example.org, as you're going
along with this course, as well,
they've got some fantastic
examples. One of such example is
going to be about libraries,
libraries are similar to
contracts. But you can't declare
any state variables and you
can't send ether. We can also
use libraries to add more
functionality to different
values. What do I mean by that?
Well, what we can do actually is
we can have get conversion rate
be a function of a un 256. So we
could do something like Messer
dot value dot get convert John,
conversion rate. And we can add
functions as if you went to 36
was an object or a struct or a
contract that we actually
created. So how do we do this?
Well, let's create a new
contract in our contracts folder
and create a new file. We're
going to call it price
converter, dot salt. And our
price converted outsole is going
to be a library that we're going
to attach to a un 256. So how do
you actually create a library
and what is a library? Well, a
library is going to be really,
really similar to a smart
contract. It's gonna start with
spdx license identifier. My
team, we're gonna give it a
pragma, solidity zero point 8.0.
And instead of typing contract
for the name of the contract,
we're going to do library for
the name of the library. We're
going to call it price
converter. Now libraries can't
have any state variables and
they also can't send ether and
all the functions in a library
are going to be in there.
kernel. So what we can do is we
can go back to fund me dot soul,
we can grab get price, get
version and get conversion rate,
copy them all, delete them from
Funmi dot soul and paste them
into our library. And of course,
since we're using aggregator v3
interface in here, we can also
copy the import from Funmi. And
since we're not using the
aggregate of three interface and
our contract anymore, and we're
using our price converter, we
can paste it into our price
converter. Now, if we compile
price converted at soul, we see
that it actually passes. Now all
the functions inside of our
library need to be internal. And
we're gonna make this library
price converter different
functions, we can call on you
activity six, for example, we're
going to be able to do message
dot value dot get conversion
rate, we're going to directly be
able to get the conversion rate
of a value of a U and 256 as if
that was a function for it the
whole time. So first, let's make
this internal. Let's make get
conversion rate internal. And
we'll make good version
internal. Now that we have this
library price converter back in
our Funmi, we can now import
this price converter and attach
it to you in 256. So we'll do
import that slash price
converter, dot soul.
And in Funmi, we'll do using
price converter for UNT 256. Of
course, if we compile our Funmi.
Now, this line is getting an
issue because saying hey, get
conversion rate isn't defined.
Now in our library, the first
variable that gets passed to the
function is going to be the
object that it's called on
itself. So in Funmi dot soul,
let's go ahead and comment out
this line for now. If we do
message dot value dot get
conversion rate, this is
secretly the same as we did get
conversion rate or message dot
value in our price converter
library, the message dot value
is going to be passed as the
input parameter to get
conversion rate, forget price
and get version we don't really
care about the number. So we're
just going to leave it blank for
now. So instead of require get
conversion rate of message dot
value, we can now do message dot
value dot get conversion rate.
And compile that you'll see that
here we're not passing a
variable, even though our get
conversion rate function says
hey, I'm expecting a variable.
Again, the reason for this is,
is this message add value is
considered the first parameter
for any of these library
functions. And that's how it
works. If we wanted another
variable in here, like you went
to 56, something else. Now we
would want to pass something
else in here 123. And this 123
would get assigned to this
something else. But we're going
to delete that for now. Okay,
great. And in doing that, we've
minimized our Funmi contract a
lot by moving a lot of that math
and price conversion stuff into
our price converter library dot
Sol. One of the most common
libraries that was used for the
longest time was this library
called Safe math dot Sol. And
you'll probably see it a lot of
different places, we're gonna go
off on a quick little tangent
here and teach you about safe
math. So let's close Funmi close
price converter. And let's
create a new file called Safe
math tester. That's all. And
let's start with some basic
stuff in here. Safe math was all
over the place before version
0.8 of solidity. And now it's
almost in no contracts. What
happened, why is safe math no
longer used as much? Well, let's
create a sample contract. This
is a section that you don't have
to follow along if you don't
want to code along with me. But
if you want to you absolutely
still can. This is going to be a
contract we are going to deploy
on a JavaScript virtual machine,
we can use any version of
solidity before version 0.8 of
solidity. So for example, we use
pragma, carrot, zero, point 6.0.
And we'll create contract safe
math tester, dot Sol. Now if I
create a you int eight, I set it
to public big number. And I set
this to 255 Oops safe math
tester. Let's go ahead and
compile safe math tester with
zero point 6.7 pragma, solidity,
the maximum size of a Yewande
eight is going to be 255. This
is going to be the biggest
number that we can fit in the
new int eight. And if I were to
deploy this to a JavaScript VM
or even a test network, safe
math tester, let's go ahead to
play up. If I hit big number,
we're gonna get 255. Well, what
happens if I create a function
called ADD? That sets big number
equal to big number plus one?
Let's save that. Delete that old
contract and deploy. All right
now big numbers 255 What happens
when we add one two? big number.
When 255 is the max size a, UNT
eight can be? Well, let's hit
add. Now let's check what big
number is. Big number gets reset
to zero. So what's going on?
Well, prior to version 0.8, of
solidity, unsigned integers and
integers ran on this concept of
being unchecked, which means
that if you passed the upper
limit of a number, it would just
wrap around and start back from
the lowest number it could be.
So if I call add a whole bunch
more times, and hit big number,
now let's say if I were to hit
this add button a ton more times
and get it back to two and a 55.
It would then continue to wrap
over to zero. So one of the most
popular libraries that was out
there was this safe math
library, which would basically
check to make sure that you
weren't wrapping around a un 256
or an intuitive six, basically,
it was a way to say, hey, you've
reached the max this number can
be and now your transaction is
going to fail. If we switch this
to 0.8, of solidity, delete the
old contract, go switch this to
0.8. We'll go ahead and compile
it. And now we deploy this to
JavaScript VM.
If I hit big number, we get to
under 55. But if we hit Add, it
actually fails. And we still get
to under 55. In version 0.8, in
solidity, they added this bit,
where it automatically checks to
make sure if you're going to do
what's called overflow or
underflow on a variable, we can
actually revert back to the
unchecked version by using an
unchecked keyword. So if we wrap
this big number equals big
number plus one in this
unchecked bracket, let's delete
our old contract will compile
will redeploy. We had big
numbers to 55. Now we hit add,
we hit big number again, it
reverted back to zero. So that's
a little bit more about safe
math, checked and unchecked. So
in version 0.76, and below this
code that you see in front of
you, is going to be the exact
same as this code in 0.8. And
above with this unchecked
keyword. Now you might be
thinking in newer versions of
solidity, why would I use this
unchecked keyword? Well, you'll
find out later that this
unchecked keyword makes your
code a little bit more gas
efficient. So if you're
absolutely positive that your
math is never going to reach the
top or bottom limits of a
number, that it might make sense
for you to use the unchecked
keyword. Let's head back over to
our Funmi contract, where we are
now using the price converter
library that we just created.
Alright, great. So now we've got
a pretty minimalistic contract
here for actually doing the
funding. And we have all of our
math for getting conversion
rates done in our library price
converter, which we're going to
import at the top of Funmi.
Cool. So at this point, we've
got our fun method. Awesome. And
so we can allow anybody to go
ahead and fund this contract and
send this contract Aetherium, or
any native blockchain currency
to this contract. Well, now what
do we want to do? Well, once all
the funders have gone ahead and
funded, we're going to want the
project to be able to withdraw
the funds out of this contract.
So they can actually go ahead
and use those funds to buy
things for this project. So
let's go ahead and create a
withdrawal function. So we'll
create a function withdraw. And
we'll make this public. Since
we're going to be withdrawing
all the funds out of this
contract, we probably also want
to reset our funders array, and
our address to amount funded.
Since we'll be withdrawing all
the funds, those amounts should
go back down to zero. So let's
go ahead and loop through the
funders array and update our
mapping object so that each of
these funders now has zero,
because in just a second, we're
going to withdraw all the money
from them. So to do this, we're
going to use something called a
for loop. So what is a for loop?
A for loop is a way to loop
through some type of index
object or loop through some
range of numbers or just do a
task a certain amount of times
repeating. So for example, let's
say we have an array or list.
And on that list, we have 1234.
If we wanted to get all of the
elements in this array, or in
this list, okay, 1234. How do we
get all the elements in this
list? Well, we would use a for
loop to loop through each one of
these objects. So at zero with
index would be one at the first
index would be two, and at the
second index would be three, at
the last index would be four. So
we would loop through the
indexes zero through three to
get all these elements. Or maybe
another example is if this was
A, B, C, D, A is at the zero
with index B is at the first
index sees the second Indy's at
the third and we will loop zero
through three. To get to each
one of these elements, we're
gonna do that exact same thing.
But with the funders array. So
how do we actually do that?
Well, we first start with the
for keyword, the for keyword
says, Okay, we're about to start
a loop. And inside of these
parentheses, we define how we
want to loop through it. Also
backslash star, and star
backslash is sort of like
brackets for comments. Anything
in between these two will be a
comment. So in a for loop,
first, we give it the starting
index, then we give it the
ending index, and then we give
it the step amount. For example,
maybe we want to start with
zero, we want to go to 10. And
we want to go up by one each
time. So we would go
01 234-567-8910. Or maybe we
start at zero, we want to end at
10. And we go up by two each
time. So we'd go 02468 10. Or
maybe we want to go from zero to
five, we want to go from two to
five, with a step of one, we'd
go 2345, etc. So this is what's
going to go inside of this four
bit here. So for our starting
index, and let me even just put
this above so that you can
reference it. So our starting
index is going to be you in to
VT six variable, and we're going
to call it funder index. And
we're going to start with
thunder index being equal to
zero. So we're starting with
zero here. And we're going to
end with the length of our
funders array, since we want to
loop through all of the funders.
So we're going to say, funder
index needs to be less than
funders dot length. So our
ending index is going to be
whenever funders index is no
longer less than funders dot
length. And then finally, we're
gonna say funder index equals
funder index, plus one, which
means that every time the code
inside of this loop finishes,
we're going to increase funder
index by one. That's how we go
from zero to one to two to three
to four to five, etc. Another
way you can type funder index
equals funder index plus one is
you can just do funder index
plus plus, this plus plus syntax
means funder index equals itself
plus one. So let's start looping
through our funders array to
access the the zero with element
or the first element, we're
going to say, funders of funder
index. So we're saying we want
to access the zero with element
of our funders object. And this
is going to return an address
for us to use, we're gonna go
ahead and say address under
equals funders at the funder
index. So now we have this
funder address. And we want to
use this to reset our mapping.
So we're going to say, address
to amount funded at at the
funder key is now equal to zero.
Because remember, in fund we
update the amount. Whenever we
fund the contract, when we
withdraw the money from the
contract, we're going to reset
it back to zero. Now let's walk
through this funder index starts
from zero. So we're going to get
the zero with funder, we're
going to grab that funder at the
zero with index and we're going
to reset the address to male
funded of that funder to zero,
then this for loop is going to
update by one, it's going to
move from zero to one, it's
going to check then if funder
index is less than the length,
let's say funders has 10 people
in it. If funders has 10 people
in it, it'll still be less. So
now funder links will be one
address funder will equal
funders of one now instead of
zero, and we'll grab that
address, and we'll reset that
addresses about funded to zero,
then we'll continue to two to
three to four all the way up to
the length of our funders array.
And this is how we can loop
through our objects. So saying
this middle one is the ending
index isn't exactly right, since
we're really checking for a
boolean to see if this is still
true, but hopefully you get the
idea. So we've reset the
balances of the mapping.
However, we still haven't done
two things, we still need to
reset the array to make the
funders a blank array. And then
we also need to actually
withdraw the funds. Since when
we funded this, we sent message
dot value along with calling
this fund function. However, we
didn't actually withdraw the
funds. So to reset the array, we
could loop through it and delete
objects from this address array.
Or we could Just totally refresh
this variable. So instead of
looping through the array and
deleting objects, we're just
going to say funders equals a
new address array, we're going
to completely reset the array by
saying this font is variable now
equals a brand new address array
with zero objects in it to
start, if we were to put a one
here, this would be there'll be
one element to start in the
array, two would be two, three
would be three, etc, we're just
going to start it as a
completely blank new array. So
great, we've gone ahead and
reset the array. But how do we
actually now with draw funds
from this contract? How do we
send the funds back to whomever
is calling this now to actually
send ether or send native
blockchain currency, there are
actually three different ways to
do this, we're going to look at
all three, and say what the
differences between the three of
them are, the three different
ways are going to be transfer,
send, and call. Let's go ahead
and start with transfer. Since
transfer is the simplest and at
surface level makes the most
sense to us. So if we want to
transfer the funds to whomever
is calling this withdrawal
function, we would do we would
say message dot sender, dot
transfer. And then we'd get the
balance of our contract here by
saying address this, this
keyword refers to this whole
contract dot balance, and we can
get the native blockchain
currency or the Aetherium
currency balance of this address
like this. And we can just do
that only thing that we need to
do is we need to cast we need to
typecast message dot sender from
an address type to a payable
address type. So message dot
sender is of type address.
Whereas payable, message that
sender is of type, payable
address, and in solidity in
order to send the native
blockchain token like Aetherium,
you can only work with payable
addresses. To do that, we just
wrap it in this payable type
caster. So this is the first way
that we actually send Aetherium
or send tokens from different
contracts to each other, we wrap
the address that we want to send
it in, in this payable keyword,
we do dot transfer, and then we
say exactly how much we want to
transfer. But there are some
issues with transfer. Here we
are on solidity by example, for
sending ether, which, again is a
fantastic resource to refer to,
if you get lost, the method that
we just looked at was this
transfer method. Now we saw way
earlier in the course, that if I
sent Aetherium, from one address
to another, it cost about 2100
gas or 2100. Gas, our transfer
function is capped at 2300 gas.
And if more gas is used, it
throws an error. The next one
that we're using is going to be
sent which is also capped at
2300 gas. And if it fails, it'll
return a Boolean. So with
transfer, if this line fails,
it'll air and revert the
transaction with send, it won't
air, it'll return a boolean of
whether or not it was
successful. So using send will
do payable message that sender
that send address this balance.
But we don't want to finish our
call here. If this were to fail,
the contract wouldn't revert the
transaction, and we just want to
get our money sent. So we want
to do Boolean send success
equals this whole bit here. And
then we want to require success.
And if this send fails will
throw an error saying sin
failed.
This way, if this fails, we will
still revert by adding our
require statement here. Transfer
automatically reverts if the
transfer fails, send will only
revert the transaction if we add
this require statement here. So
great. What's the third way that
we can actually send Etherium or
native currency wallets with
this call command. Now call is
going to be one of the first
lower level commands that we
actually use in our solidity
code, because this call function
is actually incredibly powerful.
And we can use it to call
virtually any function in all of
Aetherium without even having to
Have the API we'll learn the
advanced ways to use this call
much later. For now, we're just
going to learn how to use it to
send Aetherium, or your native
blockchain currency call is
going to look very similar to
send, we're going to do payable,
message dot sender, dot call.
And this is where we will put
any function information or any
information about the function,
we want to call on some other
contract, we actually don't want
to call a function. So we're
going to leave this blank, we
can show that we're leaving it
blank by just putting in these
two quotes here, we instead want
to use this like a transaction.
And as we saw in our deployment,
there's always this message dot
value bid, we're going to use
this call function as if it's a
regular transaction, and we can
add stuff like message dot
value. So in here, we're going
to add these squiggly brackets.
And we're going to say, value
address this dot balance, this
call function returns actually
two variables. And when a
function returns two variables,
we can show that by placing them
into parentheses on the left
hand side, the two variables, it
returns are going to be a
Boolean, that we're going to
call call success. And also a
bytes object called data
returned, since call allows us
to actually call different
functions. If that function
returns some data or returns
value, we're going to save that
in the data returned variable.
It also returns call success,
where if the function was
successfully called this will be
true. If not, this will be
false. And since bytes objects
are arrays, data returns needs
to be in memory. Now for our
code here, we're actually not
calling a function, so we don't
really care about data returned.
So similar to what we saw with
the price contract, we can just
go ahead and delete that and
leave the comma to tell solidity
Yeah, we know this function
returns two variables, but we
only care about one. And then
similar to the centerpiece
above, we're going to do require
cost access call failed, meaning
that we're requiring cost
accesses true. Otherwise, we'll
revert with an error that says
call failed. Now of learning the
difference between these three
is a little complicated for you
right now. Don't let that slow
you down. Feel free to come back
to this after you've learned
more about how some of these
lower level functions work. And
a little bit more about how
gasworks solidity by example,
does a fantastic job though of
saying what the difference is
between all three, our transfer
has a maximum of 2300 gas and
throws an error if it fails,
send has a maximum of 2300 gas
returns a Boolean, if it fails,
call forwards all gas so doesn't
have a capped gas. And similar
to send returns a Boolean, if it
is successful, or if it fails,
As of recording right now using
call is the recommended way to
actually send and receive
Aetherium or your blockchain
native token for now, if this
part's a little bit confusing
for you, for now, just look at
this and see ah, that's how we
send and transfer Aetherium or
native blockchain currency
tokens. And I'm going to delete
this part for the video, but
I'll keep those comments in the
code repository associated with
this course. And okay, perfect.
If we hit compile a fun meat
outsole, we do indeed see that
it's passing compliation.
However, there's a bit of an
issue here, right now,
anybody can withdraw from this
contract. So anybody can fund,
which is what we want. But we
don't want anyone to be able to
withdraw. We only want the
person who's collecting the
funds to be able to actually
withdraw the funds. So how do we
set this up so that the withdraw
function is only called by the
owner of this contract? Well, to
do that, we're going to set up a
couple new functions. So when we
deploy this contract, we want to
automatically set it up so that
whomever deploys this contract
is going to be the owner of this
contract. And then we can do
some parameters to set it up so
that only the owner of this
contract can call the withdrawal
function. So how would we do
that? Well, maybe we can create
a function called like, call me
right away. And right after we
deploy this contract, we call
this call me right away
function, which will set up us
as the owner. Now that's going
to take two transactions. And
that would be really annoying if
we had to do that. So instead,
solidity has something called a
constructor. And if you're
familiar with other programming
language, a constructor is
exactly the same as other
programming languages.
constructor is going to be the
function that gets called when,
immediately whenever or you
deploy a contract. So if I were
to deploy Funmi, dot Sol, and I
were to say, minimum USD equals
to minimum USD would no longer
be 50 times one e to the 18th,
it would be immediately updated
to two. Because constructor is a
function that gets immediately
called in the same transaction,
that we create this contract,
this constructor function is
going to be incredibly helpful
for us, because it allows us to
set up the contract the way we
want it to be. So for example,
if we want the withdrawal
function to only be able to be
called by the owner of this
contract, we can have the
constructor set up who the owner
of the contract is. So let's
create a global variable called
address, public owner. And then
in our constructor, we'll say
the owner is going to be equal
to the message dot sender. The
message that sender of the
constructor function is going to
be whoever is deploying the
contract. So owner is now going
to be whoever deployed this
contract. And don't worry, we're
going to demo all this very soon
and show you everything that's
going on with ether scan
everything, demoing this all
right now might take a little
bit of time, because we're using
a test net. So if you want to
test it all right now,
absolutely go for it, but just
know, it'll take you a little
bit longer to do so. Now that we
have the owner setup, we can
modify our withdrawal function
to make it so that only the
owner can actually call this
withdrawal function. So at the
top of the withdrawal function,
maybe we want to add a section,
maybe we want to say require
message dot sender equals the
owner, a note about double
equals versus equals, you can
think of this single equals as a
set parameter. So when I say
owner, is now set to message dot
sender, double equals is how you
check to see if these two
variables are equivalent. So
we're saying is message dot
sender, the same as owner. So
this is checking to see
equivalence. This is setting
checking to see equivalence
setting. So we're gonna say
require message dot sender is
equal to owner, otherwise, we're
gonna throw an error, saying,
sender is not owner. Perfect.
Now we have a quick way to make
sure the withdrawal function is
only called by the owner of this
contract. Now, let's say that
there's a lot of functions that
we have in this contract that
are going to be required to be
the owner, maybe there's a lot
of functions in this contract
that need a whole lot of
different requires, we don't
want to have to copy paste this
line to every single one of our
functions. So what can we do?
Well, this is where something
called modifiers come in. So for
now, we're gonna go ahead and
delete this line. And below,
we're going to create something
called a modifier, our modifier
is going to be a key word that
we can add right in the function
declaration. To modify the
function with that
functionality, we're going to
create a modifier and call it
only owner. And we're going to
paste that line that we just
made in withdraw. And underneath
that, we're going to put a
little underscore, what I can do
now is I can take this only
owner modifier, and stick it in
the function declaration of my
withdrawal function. So what's
happening with this modifier
with only owner in this function
declaration,
we're saying, hey, for this
withdrawal function, before you
read all this code inside of it,
look down at the only owner
modifier and do whatever is in
there first, and then do
whatever's in the underscore,
this underscore represents doing
the rest of the code. So now,
when we go call the withdraw
function, we actually do this
require statement first, and
then call the rest of the code.
If this require statement, we're
below the underscore, this would
tell our function to go ahead
and do all this code first. And
then run the require. Because
again, we have this only only
keyword, we're saying, Great,
we've got a function, it's
withdraw its public, oh, only
odor modifier. Let's look at how
that works. Okay, it tells us
how to do all the code of the
original function first. So
let's go ahead and do that.
Okay, now we're done. Now, what
do we do? Okay, now we'll run
the require, we want to go ahead
and put the require here first.
So this is how modifiers work,
and how we can use them to
improve our functionality. All
right, awesome. We have all the
basic functionality of our
contract that we need here. Now
we're finally actually going to
run everything on a test and see
everything happened live before
our eyes. Are you ready? Let's
do this.
So let's go over to the deploy
tab. And we're going to switch
of course to injected web three.
Remember But we're using
injected web three, because our
price converter dot soul is
using chainlink Oracle's that
actually exist and are actually
monitoring the Rinkeby network
for us. Now we're going to
scroll down to, and we're going
to choose the Funmi contract.
And we're going to go ahead and
deploy. Once again, we want to
make sure we're on the Rinkeby
test net. And we have a little
bit of rinky eath in our wallet,
let's go ahead and deploy,
confirm. And we'll wait a little
bit. And I'll pull up our log
here. And we'll wait a little
bit for our contract to get
deployed. Alright, great. It
looks like our contract has
indeed been deployed. If we
scroll down, we can see all of
our functionality, minimum USD
is going to be that $50. But
with 18 zeros so that the units
are the same as Aetherium, the
owner of our contract was set to
our address, the instant we
deployed this contract, it was
deployed by calling our
constructor function. So this
address 0x 106 x is going to be
the same as the address in our
meta mask, your address here, of
course, is going to be a little
bit different than mine, we have
our funders array, which, of
course is going to be blank, we
have our address array, which is
also going to be blank. And then
we have two functions that we
can use to modify the state of
the blockchain withdraw is going
to be orange, because we're not
paying any Aetherium we're
actually gaining Aetherium or
whatever native blockchain
currency fund is going to be
read, because fun is a payable
function that we are going to be
sending Aetherium to or sending
whatever native blockchain
currency that you're working
with. So let's go ahead and see
how this all works. So first,
let's go ahead and fund this
contract. Again, funding, we got
to do a little bit of math,
right now, since the price of
eath is around $3,000. And we're
looking for $50. Minimum, we do
50 divided by 3000. We can do
3000 divided by 50, we can do 50
divided by 3000. So we know that
around 0.02 Aetherium, should be
enough for this contract to
work. So 0.02 Aetherium is this
much way, we can copy that,
paste that into here. So when we
hit fund, it should actually
pass. And we do indeed see meta
masks pop up. And we'll go ahead
and confirm. Once this
transaction goes through, we'll
be able to see this contract on
ether scan with the funds in it.
Now if we don't add way here, if
we don't add a value, once
again, we had fund will say gas
estimation failed because we're
not sending enough here. And in
fact, we even see execution
reverted didn't send enough, we
can absolutely send this
transaction however, it's going
to fail. Great. So now that our
transaction has gone through, if
we go on to the rink the ether
scan, once we wait a little bit
for it to finish indexing here
on the Rinkeby ether scan, we
can see that transaction
actually went through for doing
the funding, we can actually see
a lot of different details going
on with this transaction as
well. And if we scroll down, we
once again, you can see all the
information about us calling
this fun function, gas limit
gas, you should the gas fees,
gas price, and we can see the
input data as well, we can see
that we called the fund function
down here. We'll learn more
about the input data later. If
we go to the contract that we
deployed, we can now see two
transactions, we can see our
contract created transaction.
And we can also see we called a
font method. And if we look at
the balance of our contract, and
now has 0.02 ether, which makes
sense, since we just sent it
0.02. If we put that 0.02 eath
in terms of way back into the
value section, and we call font
again, after this transaction
goes through, we should see this
number go from 0.02 to 0.04. Now
after we wait a brief delay, we
do indeed see the balance has
gone up to 0.04, which is
exactly what we'd expect.
Awesome. So our funding
mechanism is working correctly.
And if we go down into our
array, and our mapping
to do address to array, and we
paste our address, we should see
the phone number show up. And if
we go to funders of zero, we see
our address. And if we go to
funders of one, we also see our
address and we see that and we
see this call going through if
we go to funders have to in our
log over here, we actually see
that we get an error an
optimization that we could make
to our contract in the future is
to check to see if an address is
already in the funders array and
then not add it if it's already
there. Now let's go ahead and
try to call this withdrawal
function. But let's try to call
it with a different address than
the address we originally
deployed this contract with. So
to do that, scroll all the way
to the top of this here. And I'm
going to go to my Metamask. And
I'm going to switch to a second
account and hit connect. Now,
our remixes should be updated
with the new account that's in
here, you'll see that if I
switch back to account one, it
switches back to account one, so
long as they're both connected,
you can see which accounts are
connected to applications by
clicking this connected button
and see which ones are
connected. If you ever want to
disconnect that account, you can
click the three little dots and
it disconnect the account. And
now we can see that this account
is not connected. However, count
two is connected. Let's go back
to account one and Connect
account one so that both of them
are now connected. But we'll
switch to account two, let's
switch to account two, because
again, account two isn't the
owner of this contract. We
scroll down to owner, we can see
owner's 0x 1066 Something
something and account two is
0x 043. Something something
awesome. So what do you think
will happen when we hit withdraw
here? Well, our modifier only
owner should kick in. And we
should get notified that if we
send the transaction, we'll get
this error sender is not owner.
So let's try it. Ah gas
estimation failed, we do get
this error. Sender is not owner,
which is perfect. This is
exactly what we want, we could
absolutely send this transaction
if we wanted to. But that would
just be a waste of gas because
this transaction is going to
fail. However, if we switch back
to account one, and we hit
withdraw, meta mask will pop up,
enabling us to confirm and
withdraw the ether out of this
contract address. Now if we look
at this contract address on
ether scan, after a brief delay,
we'll see the balance go from
0.04 back down to zero. And
we'll see our wallet balance go
up from what it is back to 0.04
plus what it was. And after a
brief delay, you can see our
balance is indeed back down to
zero in our contract. Now, if we
do address to amount for our
wallet address that was doing
the funding, it's back down to
zero. And if we try to check the
address of funders at index
zero, we get called to funders
that fund me errored execution
reverted.
We've completed all the basics
of this section that I wanted to
go through. And you should be
incredibly proud of yourself for
getting this far, you've just
deployed a really advanced smart
contract, we're using a library
and chainlink contracts to build
some of the most powerful
applications in the planet,
we've learned to use a library
for any type we want in our
smart contracts. We've learned
more about multiplication, and
then units of measure in
solidity and smart contracts.
We've learned about mappings
more about arrays what the
constructor does, we've learned
how to send money we've learned
about for loops, we've learned
about the different ways we can
actually send money, at least
from a low level. And we've
learned about modifiers. This
section is one of the tougher
sections in this course. So if
you completed this, you should
be incredibly excited. We're
going to go through our code
now. And we're going to make a
number of tweaks. Now this
section, we are going to do a
little bit more advanced
solidity here. So if you get a
little bit lost, don't sweat it
too much. And feel free to try
some of this stuff in the future
on your own. We're going to
modify this contract to make it
a little bit more professional.
It's not going to be end to end
amazing, but it's going to be a
little bit better. And you'll
see why in a minute. So the
first thing that we're going to
do is we're looking we're going
to look at some of these
variables here. In particular
owner and minimum USD, owner
gets set one time in our
contract here. And then it never
changes. Again, minimum USD gets
set one time, even outside of
the constructor. If we have
variables that only get set one
time, we can actually use some
tools in solidity to make them
more gas efficient. For now
let's compile our Funmi
contract, and then deploy it to
a JavaScript virtual machine.
Remember, we can go ahead and
deploy it right now. However,
funding and withdrawing and
doing in the money stuff isn't
going to work. Because again, we
don't have a chain link network
on our JavaScript VM. So those
aren't going to work so well.
But for what we're gonna do
right now, we don't really care
so much. Here's what we do care
about. You do care about how
much gas this costs to actually
send. We do care about how much
gas is costs to create right now
creating this contract costs
about 859,000 gas and we're
going to Add a couple of tricks.
Right now to bring this number
down, we're going to add some
stuff back in in the bid, which
will bring it back up. But for
now, we're going to learn some
tricks to bring this number
down. The two tricks that we're
going to learn are the constant
keyword and the immutable
keyword, in their solidity.
There are two keywords that make
it so that your variables can't
be changed. And those keywords
are constant and immutable. You
can learn more about them in the
solidity documentation, if you
assign a variable once outside
of a function, and then never
change it, so if if it's
assigned at compile time, you
can go ahead and add this
constant keyword. We'll learn
later about storage. But when
you add a constant keyword, this
minimum USD no longer takes up a
storage spot, and is much easier
to read too. So now we recompile
this, and we deploy this new
contract. Let's see if we saved
any gas. We look in the
transaction logs, now, we can
grab the transaction cost of how
much this cost to deploy, let's
compare it to how much it was
before. Well, we saved almost
19,000 gas, that's almost as
much gas as a cost to send
Aetherium. Typically, constant
variables have a different
naming convention. Typically,
you'll want to do them all caps
like Min imaam. Underscore, who
is the CIO all caps with
underscores. So now let's just
find minimum use D, and replace
that with all caps as well. With
this interaction, we know that
this variable is a constant
variable, and it's much cheaper
to read from now, if we go ahead
and compile this and redeploy.
In our Funmi contract, even
though this is a view function,
remember, view functions do have
gas costs when when called by
contract as a constant variable,
we can see the execution cost of
this variable 21,415 gas. So
let's put a little note rather
Nathan.
If we remove the constant
variable, we delete this
contract. And we redeploy, like
Funmi. And we hit minimum ust
again, we can now see how much
gas this was cost. If it wasn't
a constant variable, we can see
the gas cost did indeed go up.
Now on chains that are much
cheaper, this gas difference
probably won't make that much of
a difference. But on more
expensive chains like Aetherium,
this is going to make a big
difference. For example, on
Aetherium, we can actually see
current gas prices on Aetherium.
Here, we can see the current gas
price of Aetherium is about 141
way, so we'll go to our
converter, way to way we'll copy
the way price times this will
get the gas price of calling our
minimum USD, which is this
number here, which if we put
back in our Aetherium
uniconverter, we can see cost
this much gas. And if we times
that by the approximate current
price of Aetherium, which is
around $3,000. Calling minimum
use D as a constant is going to
cost $9 on the inside is at a
nonconstant is going to cost
almost an entire dollar more,
you can see how all these little
gas optimization tricks are
going to make your life a lot
better. So let's keep this
constant keyword in here. We'll
learn more about constant and
storage in later sections of
this course. Now, as you're just
getting started with this
course, and with slip the Do not
struggle. And do not worry about
making your contracts as gas
efficient as possible in the
beginning, and especially right
now. Just write your contracts
as best as you can. Once you get
really good at gas. And once you
get much later on in the course,
and much more advanced with
solidity, then you can start
going back and working on gas
optimizations. But do not let
gas optimizations hold you back.
Or if you start stressing over
it, just let it go. Don't worry
about it and just write your
code as best you can. So long
story short, Do not stress about
gas optimizations right now. Now
another variable we only set one
time is going to be our owner
variable. Owner equals message
dot sender. We set this one time
in the constructor variables
that we set one time but outside
of the same line that they're
declared. And we set them for
example, in the constructor, we
can mark as a mutable typically
a good convention for marking
immutable variables is going to
be doing I underscore so that we
know that these are immutable
variables, they have very
similar gas savings to the
constant keyword. Owner, of
course, is a variable that we
can't set on the line here
because inside the global scope,
there's no function going on.
However, inside functions,
because inside the global scope,
there's going to be no message
that sender, there's only going
to be a message dot sender when
we're inside of a function. So
inside here, we might say I
owner equals message dot sender.
And then of course, we'll scroll
down and we'll change this
require only owner now equals i
owner. Now if we compile that
deploy up, we can see how much
gas we can see how much gas
calling I owner is going to be
by with immutable notice, we get
21,508, which we'll go ahead and
copy for now. And we'll put
right here, we'll say,
immutable. Now, if we remove the
immutable keyword, let's close
this redeploy. If we scroll down
to I owner, screw up the logs,
we go down to the call, scroll
down, we see the execution cost
was much more. So we'll do the
backslash, a seven here, yes, or
non immutable. So you want to
keep some of these tricks in
mind, when it comes to storing
variables. The reason that these
two save gas is because instead
of storing these variables
inside of a storage slot, we
actually store them directly
into the bytecode of the
contract. And like I said, don't
worry too much about that for
now, later on in the course,
we'll teach you more about
storage and a lot of this low
level stuff that comes to these
contracts. But for now, just
know that these exist. And
they're nice gas savers, if
you're only setting your
variables once. Alright, great.
So we've just made our contract
a little bit more gas efficient,
little gas efficiency
improvements are going to be
concept I sprinkled throughout
this course. And when we get to
the more advanced section, I'm
going to break down exactly
what's going on and why all
these gas efficiencies exist and
what's going on behind the
scenes for these gas
efficiencies to occur. It's a
little bit in the weeds, which
is why I'm going to gloss over
it right now.
So if it's confusing, don't
worry, I wouldn't let these gas
efficiencies be the thing that
slow you down. Awesome. So we
have these two gas
optimizations? How else can we
make this contract a little bit
more gas efficient? Well, one of
the ways we can make this more
gas efficient, is by updating
our requires right now with our
require statement, we actually
have to store this sender is not
an owner as a string array,
every single one of these
characters in this errorlog
needs to get stored
individually, this string may
not seem very big, but it's a
lot bigger than the alternative
with what we can do. As of zero,
point 8.4 of solidity, you can
now actually do custom errors.
For our reverts, we declare them
at the top and then use ifs,
instead of require and then just
add a revert statements. This
ends up saving a lot of gas,
since we just call the error
code, as opposed to calling the
entire string associated with
the air. So for example, with
our require down here, and with
actually with all of our
requires, well we could do is
instead of having this require
we could create a custom error.
So at the top, what we could do
is we could say error, not
owner. And you'll notice that
this is actually outside of the
contract here. Now what we can
do is we can take this error not
owner scroll down into our only
owner, instead of doing a
require we'll do an if
statement, we'll say if message
dot sender is not owner, then
we're going to go ahead and
revert with a non owner error.
This ends up saving us a lot of
gas, since we don't have to
store and emit this long string
here. Now in a lot of code
today, you'll still see require
a lot of places because these
these custom errors are pretty
new in solidity. So you'll want
to get used to writing in both
ways. I wouldn't be surprised if
in the future, the syntax for
some of these errors looks like
this so that it's more readable.
But for now, if you want to do a
more gas efficient way than
required, you can use something
like this, we could update all
of our requires here for these
customers. But for now, I'm
going to leave both in just to
show you the differences. This
revert keyword does the exact
same thing that required us
without the conditional
beforehand. So you can actually
go ahead and revert any
transaction or any function call
in the middle of the function
call. Now let's look at one more
way to improve this contract.
Sometimes people will try to
interact with the contract that
takes Aetherium or the native
blockchain token without
actually going through the
required function calls that
that are needed. For example, on
a JavaScript EVM here, I could
actually try to send this
contract money without calling
the fund function. However, if I
were to do that, what would
happen with our fund function
get triggered? No, it wouldn't
get triggered, we wouldn't keep
track of that funder, we
wouldn't have that person's
information updated in this
contract. So if later on we want
to give rewards or something we
wouldn't know about those
funders. And this wouldn't be
great because people would send
our contract money without us
ever knowing and we wouldn't be
able to give them any credit or
anything. Additionally, maybe
they called the wrong function
by accident, and they they
weren't using Metamask. And they
weren't using a tool to tell
them, hey, this transaction is
likely going to fail. So what
can we do in this case? What
happens if someone sends this
contract, ether without calling
the fun function? Right now, if
we were to send this Funmi
contract, ie it would just go to
the contract Right, and this
contract just wouldn't keep
track of those people. But
there's actually a way for when
people send money to this
contract, or people call a
function that doesn't exist for
us to still trigger some code.
And now there are two special
functions in solidity one is
called receive, and one is
called the fallback. Now in
solidity, there are actually a
number of special functions and
two of these special functions
are the receive special
function. And the fallback
special function, a contract can
have at most one receive
function declared using the
received external payable.
Without the function keyword.
This function cannot have
arguments cannot return anything
and must have external
visibility, and a payable state
mutability. What does that
actually mean? And or look like?
Well, let's create a separate
contract to go ahead and play
with this. So in here, we're
going to create a new file
called fallback example, dot
soul. And in here, we're going
to add our basic pieces, SPX
license identifier, MIT pragma,
solidity zero, point 8.7. And
we'll do contract fallback
example, like so, feel free to
pause the video to catch up to
this point, let's recreate our
fallback contract, let's create
a variable to go ahead and try
to test this function, we'll
create a un 256 public result
variable. And let's create this
receive function. So we'll say
receive, it's going to be an
external payable.
function, we don't add the
function keyword for receive,
since solidity knows that
receive is a special function
whenever we send Aetherium or
make a transaction to this
contract. Now, as long as
there's no data associated with
that transaction, this receive
function will get triggered.
What we can do in here now is we
can say result equals one. So
let's go ahead and test this out
on the JavaScript virtual
machine, we compile this, so
we're gonna go ahead and compile
this. And we'll go deploy it on
the Java Virtual Machine, we're
going to deploy our fallback
example. And we're going to see
what result is initialized to,
since we haven't set anything
for result, result, of course,
is initialized zero. But what if
we were to send this contract
some Aetherium? Well receive
would go ahead and be triggered
here, we can actually send this
contract some material directly
by working with this low level
interactions. But here, don't
worry about what call data means
for now, just know that this
area down here is a way we can
send and work with different
functions. And we can add
parameters to this transaction,
by going up here and adjusting
the variables up here. If we
keep called Data blank, it'll be
the same as if we were in
Metamask. And just hitting send
in the choosing this contract
address. Again, we can't
actually use Metamask, since
this is a virtual machine, and
not one of the networks that
we're working with. So if I do,
for example, I change this value
to one way, and I keep
everything blank. And I go ahead
and hit this transaction button,
which again, is going to be the
same as hitting this Send
button, but only sending one
way. What do you think will
happen? Well, let's try it. We
can see in the log area that we
did indeed send a transaction.
And if you look at the
description here, you can even
see it says from so and so to
fall back example, dot receive,
it looks like it called our
received function, which should
have updated our result to one.
So if we hit result, now we can
indeed see that result has been
updated to the value of one.
Well, let's go ahead and delete
this. Let's deploy this contract
again. And this time, let's have
this value be zero, does receive
get triggered this time. So
let's pull this down. Let's hit
transact. Let's leave the call
data blank, we'll leave value at
zero. So this will be the same
as if we had sent zero Aetherium
to this contract. Let's hit
transact. It looks like that
went through, do you think
result is going to be one or
zero? You thought one you were
correct or receive function gets
triggered anytime we send a
transaction to this contract
now, and we don't specify a
function. And we keep the call
data blank when working with any
other contract like Funmi. For
example, when we call one of
these functions, we're actually
just populating this call data
bit with certain data that
points to one of these functions
up here. If we send a
transaction and we add data to
it, we could actually call one
of these functions. Now let's
try this again. Let's delete the
contract again we'll redeploy
open this up result is currently
zero receive like I said only is
triggered if our call data to it
is blank. Now this time if I had
some call data to this
transaction, do you think
receive will be triggered this
time? If we hit transact and
remix we actually get a pop up
saying fallback function is not
defined. This is because
whenever data is sent with a
transaction solidity says, Oh,
well, since you're sending data
you're not looking for receive,
you're looking for some
function. So let me look for
that function for you. Hmm, I
don't see any function that
matches the 0x 00. So I'm going
to look for your fallback
function. Remix is smart enough
to know that we don't have a
fallback function. The second
special function in solidity is
called the fallback function.
This is very similar to the
receive function, except for the
fact that can work even when
data is sent along with
transaction. So our fallback
will look something like this
callback,
external payable. result equals
to Fallback is another one of
these functions where we're not
going to put the function
selector because solidity is
expecting this, actually, you're
already familiar with one other
special function, we go back to
our Funmi. Our constructor, for
example, is a another type of
special function. There's no
function keyword. solidity knows
that this constructor is
immediately called when we
deploy this contract. So now we
have our fallback function.
Let's go ahead and compile this.
Let's delete our old contract.
Let's go ahead and deploy this
new contract. Like here, we hit
result, we do indeed, see, it's
set to zero. Now, if I add this
0x 00, and I send this, and I
hit transact, this is equivalent
to calling our contract here
without a valid function. So our
contract goes, Huh, I don't
recognize what you're trying to
tell me here, I'm going to refer
you to our fallback. And now if
we hit result, we see that it's
been updated to two. If we take
this away, solidity will go,
Hmm, it looks like you're trying
to send some Aetherium, or call
this contract without specifying
what you want to do. Well, I
have a receipt function. So I'm
just gonna go ahead and forward
you to that. So if we call
transact, we hit result, we see
it updates back to one, add some
data, hit transact, we see it
updates to to no data, updates
to one slowly by example, that
org has a wonderful little chart
that we can use to figure out
whether or not receive is going
to get triggered, or Fallback is
going to get triggered. If it is
empty, and there's a receive
function, it'll call the receive
function. If it is data, and
there's no receive function,
it'll just go to the fallback
function. And if there's no
fallback function, it might just
it might air out. So this is a
lot of really fantastic
information here. How can we
apply this to our fund mi
contract here, or what we can do
now in our Funmi is we can add
these fallback and receive
functions, just in case somebody
actually sends us contract money
instead of calling the fund
function correctly. So what we
can do is let's add a receive
function. So if somebody
accidentally sends it money, we
can still process the
transaction will say receive is
going to be external payable.
And we'll just have the receive
function call fund. And we'll do
the same thing with our fallback
function will have fallback
external payable. We'll just
have it automatically call fund.
Now, if somebody accidentally
sends us money without calling
our fund function, it'll still
automatically route them over to
the fund function. This means to
that if somebody doesn't send us
enough funding, it'll, that
transaction will still get
reverted. So let's go ahead now.
And let's switch to rink B to
test this on a real test net,
Amman rink B and my Metamask.
Let's switch over to injected
web three. And we'll scroll down
we'll choose our Funmi contract.
And we'll go ahead and deploy
this Metamask pops up, I'm gonna
go ahead and confirm the
transaction. And we see our
Funmi contract here right now we
can see the owner we can see I'm
the owner, we can see minimum
USD. And we can see of course
that it's a blank contract, and
there's nothing funded in here.
If we the copy the address, and
then go to rink the ether scan,
paste the address in, we can see
that there's no ether in here.
And the only transaction
associated with this has been
the contract creation. We saw
what happened before when we hit
the fun function, our contract
was updated with a new balance,
and that funder was added to our
an array. Let's see what happens
now if we just directly send
this contract money without
calling the fund function here.
If we did this right, our
receive function should pick it
up and kick the transaction over
the font. So let's copy this
address. We'll go to our meta
mask. We'll hit send, paste the
address in here with 0.02 eath.
Again, because this should be
more than the minimum amount in
USD, we'll hit next. I'll go
ahead and confirm this. After a
slight delay, if we did this
right, we should see the
transaction having called the
fund function here, now that our
transaction has gone through
After a brief delay in waiting
for ethers can update, we do
indeed see that our balance has
updated to 0.02, which of
course, this makes sense. And we
see in the transactions list
here, we see that this actually
went through as a, as a transfer
instead of us calling the fund
function. Let's go ahead and
remix and see if our funders was
updated.
It looks like it was at the zero
with position of funders, we
have our address. And if we take
our address and pop it into
address to amount funded, we can
see exactly how much we had
funded. This means that since we
added this receive function in
here, we automatically had to
call our fun function up here.
So awesome work, we were able to
add a receive function to help
people who accidentally call the
wrong function or accidentally
send this contract money,
instead of correctly calling the
fun function. Now, if they had
directly called the fun
function, it would have cost
them a little bit less gas, but
at least this time, they're
gonna get credit and add it to
our funders array for having
sent our funding contract money.
We've even learned some advanced
sections of solidity. And this
is going to be the last time
that we start our projects in
remix, we're going to be moving
over to a code editor now, where
we can get even more advanced
with our solidity on our setups.
For the most part, you've gone
over the vast majority of
solidity basics, there are a
number of things that we still
haven't learned yet. And the
reason we haven't gotten into
them is because they get more
advanced. And understanding the
real use doesn't really make too
much sense until a little bit
later. Some of the things that
we're going to go over are itams
events, try catch function
selectors, abi encoding,
hashing, and then you will slash
and then you will slash
assembly. However, if you've
gotten this far, you probably
can read most solidity code and
understand what's going on,
which is absolutely fantastic.
So you should give yourself a
huge round of applause for
getting this far. And doing
this. Let's do a quick summary
of this more advanced section
and make sure we understand what
we learned in solidity there are
a couple special functions. Some
of them are receive fallback,
and Constructor. These functions
don't need to have the function
keyword. And instead it can just
be called like so. Receive and
fallback are two very special
functions. If data is sent with
a transaction, and no function
was specified, the transaction
will default to the fallback
function if that fallback
function exists. If data is
empty, and there's a receive
function, it'll call the receive
function. There are a couple of
keywords that can help us save
gas in the long run. Some of
those keywords are going to be
constant and immutable. Constant
and immutable are for variables
that can only be declared and
updated once. Once we say
minimum USD is 50 times 118.
This minimum USD can never be
changed again. And this helps us
save gas. Immutable can also
save gas similar to constant.
However, immutable variables can
be declared one time in the
constructor, once an immutable
variable is declared, it can't
be changed later on. In fact, if
we even tried to update an
immutable variable or constant
variable, and we compiled, a
compiler would give us an error
saying, Can't write to a mutable
here. Or if we tried to change a
constant variable. Our compiler
would say, Hey, you can't assign
to a constant variable, sorry.
In remix, if we want to send
ether to a contract that's on
the JavaScript virtual machine,
we can deploy that contract. And
then in the contract, we can
just hit the transact button
without any call data and update
the value that we send with the
transaction. If call data is
blank, it will trigger the
receive function if it exists.
But if there's data that doesn't
specify any of the other
functions, it'll trigger the
fallback function
Awesome, you've done
fantastically to get this far.
And for this section before we
get started actually moving over
to Hardhead. And moving over to
JavaScript and understanding why
we need to do that. Let's
understand a little bit about
getting help and running into
problems. So let's say we have
our Funmi contract here that we
just worked on. And we run into
an error. Let's say for example,
we forgot the payable keyword,
right, and we go ahead and
compile this compile fund, we
did so. And we scroll down. And
we see obviously, we have two
errors here, right, we're
getting some errors, and we
scroll down. And we see type
error message dot value and call
value can only be used and
payable public functions, make
the function payable or using an
internal function to avoid this
error. And then it goes ahead
and gives the line that's
airing. Now this error is pretty
clear, this error code is pretty
clear. It's saying Hey, make the
function payable, or using an
internal function to avoid this
error, right? This should be
pretty easy to to add payable,
and then recompile and be good
to go. And this is actually a
good example of what to do when
you run into errors. When you
run into errors. The first thing
you want to do is you want to
try to figure out exactly what's
going on yourself based off of
what the error says. This one's
pretty straightforward, but some
of them can be a little bit more
obscure step one when trying to
get unblocked trying to tinker
and figure out errors yourself,
right? Because maybe you go
okay, I'll make this payable,
right? And you go to save. And
then it gives a different error
saying, hey, you know, payable
doesn't go here. You resave you
recompile it goes, Hey, we're
still missing that payable
thing. First step is always
going to be trying to tinker and
figure it out yourself. For this
course, I want you to limit
tinkering, slash triaging to 20
minutes, if you take more than
20 minutes to tinker and triage,
then move on to the next step.
But I also want you to take at
least 15 minutes yourself or be
100% Sure, you exhausted all
options, you're completely out
of ideas. So typically try to
tinker try some stuff for 15
minutes. And if you're under 15
minutes, and you're saying, Hey,
I'm 100% Certain I've tried
everything that I can think of,
then you can move on to the next
step. So step one, when you run
into errors is always going to
be tinker and try to pinpoint
exactly what's going on. Try to
pinpoint exactly what's going
wrong. Step two, let's say you
tinkered and you tried payable
all over the place, and you
couldn't figure out what this
error was and how to debug this
here. Step two is always going
to be Google the exact error and
see if you can learn from that.
So zoom out a little bit, I'll
roll my mouse over this, grab
this, copy it, or quotes around
it, and do exactly that, in
Google search that exact error
and take some time going through
Google going through Stack
Overflow going through Stack
Exchange eath, and look to see
if somebody has asked this
question already. And it looks
like down here looks like
somebody has type error missed a
value and call though can only
be used on PayPal public
functions. And if we scroll
down, we see that somebody ran
into exactly this. And they went
ahead and solved it. They go, I
realized my mistake, I needed to
add the PayPal keyword to my own
implementation. And they go
ahead in this question, they've
added the payable. And hopefully
this would give you the insight
to say, Ah, okay, great. I do
need to come back here and add
payable. Let's say this
StackOverflow question didn't
show up. Right? This forum
wasn't here. What do we do next?
So step one, tinker. Step two,
Google the exact error, I'm
going to do a step 2.5 That only
is for this class, go to our
GitHub, repo discussions, and or
updates for this course,
specifically, go to this GitHub
repo, full blockchain solidity
course, Jas, it'll look a little
bit different when you all get
to it. But come to this repo,
and look in this chronological
update section to see if there's
an update on that section that
you're doing. Obviously, since
I'm recording right now, there's
no update. And if you don't get
anything, feel free to jump into
the discussion section. And ask
a question in here, right,
there's going to be a community
of people looking to help each
other out and looking to make
this a lot of fun. And the
reason I say 2.5 is because in
the real world, you're not going
to have our GitHub repo, when
working on stuff outside of this
course, you're not going to have
this GitHub repo. So instead, in
the real world, I'm still going
to give you the keys, I'm going
to give you what it takes to
still unblock yourself on
anything. Okay. So number three
is going to be asked a question
on a forum, like stack, exchange
eath and Stack Overflow. Stack
Overflow is a question and
answering tech forum like this,
right? You can ask tech
questions, and then you can
answer them as well. And as you
can see, when you search for
these issues, they'll show up so
Stack Overflow is more for
general Role programming
questions and Stack Exchange
Aetherium or Stack Exchange eath
Aetherium Stack Exchange, this
is for more Aetherium or EVM
based question and all the
solidity code that we're gonna
be working with, whether it's
polygon, whether it's avalanche,
whether it's whatever, those
questions are going to be valid
here, and you can ask here. So
what you'd want to do is you'd
want to sign up or log in, and
ask and format your questions on
these forms, you'll want to sign
up for GitHub, you want to sign
up for Stack Exchange, you'll
want to sign up for Stack
Overflow, so you can participate
in these forums. In fact, if you
haven't already, let's sign up
for GitHub right now. And let me
walk you through formatting one
of these questions, because the
better you format your
questions, the better chance you
have of actually getting the
answer. And remember, when
asking questions on these
forums, when asking questions,
in these discussion communities,
people answer these questions
out of the goodness of their
heart, right? So if you don't
get a response, there's a chance
that maybe nobody knows, maybe
it's your question isn't
formatted very well, and etc. So
we're going to learn how to ask
really good questions here. And
if you're new to blockchain, do
not skip this section. Okay,
this is going to be that piece
that's going to give you the
superpower to unblock yourself
from any coding issue you run
into. So don't skip this
powerup. Be sure to follow
along. Okay. So if you don't
have a GitHub already, you do
need an email to get started. So
I'm going to go ahead and sign
in, I made a burner account just
for this video. So what we're
gonna do, we're gonna go ahead
and sign up GitHub, enter your
email
and we hit Create Account,
they're going to send us an
email. So we're going to come
back to our email, and we got
our launch code here, paste it
in. And so a little bit of
information. We're going to
choose the free version. and
fantastic. We've now created a
GitHub profile. Now back over in
the smart contract kid full
blockchain solidity course, Jas,
I'm going to create a new
discussion, a new thread, and I
want you all to comment on to
make sure you understand how to
format and how to ask questions.
Okay, general thread for
practicing. Question formatting.
Oops. And so let's go back here.
So first, I'm going to format
this question poorly, two ways,
and then we're gonna format it
really, really well. So the
first way we're going to format
it poorly, is by not giving
enough information. So what
we're going to do is I'm gonna
just copy this issue we're going
to do is we'll just say like,
Hey, I'm having trouble with
remix and an error. Can someone
help me? Why is this not a well
formatted question? If this is
my question, there's not nearly
enough information here, I, as a
helper, have no idea what this
person's asking. So let's do
something else. What I'm going
to do is I'm going to copy this
entire contract all the fun,
read outsole, paste it in here,
and go, Hi, I'm having issues
here. Can someone help? I'm
gonna head start discussion here
want to hit start discussion, it
formats this all weird. And once
again, there's not really enough
information here. I don't know
what the issue is. But at least
with this one, we have some
code, we have some way to
actually debug. So this is a
little bit better. But it's
still not that good. Let's go
ahead and edit this. To make
this even better. We hit three
dots, we can hit edit, what we
can do is we can use something
called Markdown syntax, and
highly recommend learning a
little bit of markdown, it's
basically some syntax help make
discussions on GitHub. And also,
questions on Stack Overflow and
Stack Exchange a lot easier. So
we're going to format this code
by adding these three backticks
at the start, and then also at
the end of our code. And then
additionally, next, the first
three backticks, we're going to
type so lid did T which tells
the format or to to use solidity
to format this code here. Now if
we update discussion, we notice
we get some nice highlighting
here. So this becomes much, much
easier to read. Right? This is
way easier to read now than than
it was before. However, it's
still not specific enough. We've
given a ton of code here, and we
haven't given the specific
answer. So this is gonna be
really hard for somebody to
answer. So let's make this more
specific. So let's edit this
question again. And let's
specify, so we see here, our
issue is specifically on this
function. We're going to copy
this function and we're going to
delete everything else in here.
And now we have just this code
inside of here. Now we're going
to make this really specific.
We're going to say, on this
function, I'm running into an
error. And then what we're going
to do is we're going to come
back here, we're going to roll
the over this. We're going to
copy this we could have pull our
code if we want but we're going
to format this error like this.
And then we're gonna say Can
someone tell me What's going on?
Update? Now this is a much, much
easier question to debug. Right?
We have some minimalistic code,
we have the error that we're
getting. And we have Can someone
tell me what's going on?
Obviously, the answer to this
would be to add payable to this.
And that's what somebody would
say, hey, like, you need to add
payable to this, I want you all
to practice doing some
formatting, go ahead and add a
comment on this with your own
formatted question. So that you
understand how to actually do
the formatting. And this
markdown format. It's this
format here, that's gonna be the
exact same for asking questions
on Stack Overflow, or Stack
Exchange for this course, go
ahead and practice if you want
to create more new discussions,
feel free to create new
discussions. If you want to use
Stack Overflow or Stack Exchange
eath actually highly recommend
you Stack Overflow or Stack
Exchange eath as well, because
those are gonna get indexed a
lot better than GitHub here.
However, feel free to ask
questions, obviously, in this
GitHub as well. Now that I've
given you kind of the basics
rundown, we're going to watch a
video that I made that goes even
deeper into why and how to
format all these questions and
what to use. So let's go ahead
and watch that. Every developer
has run into this. Something
breaks or maybe you don't know
something, but you don't have
time to let these stop you.
There are a series of steps that
one should take to maximize
one's chances of solving any
coding problem, but you'd be
surprised at how few developers
currently use the superpower
effectively, our first one we'll
spend the least time on, because
it's just tinker and experiment.
When you run into an issue. Keep
trying different things you
think might work, maybe try
doing print statements
throughout the file, learn some
debugging tips, but don't be so
cocky that you only do this
first step. And this shouldn't
just be random running around.
This should be trying to
pinpoint exactly what's going
wrong in your code, so that you
can either ask an effective
question, or figure it out
yourself. So pinpoint exactly
what's going wrong, because
you'll need it for the next
steps. Anyways, next, check the
documentation. Not all tools
have good documentation. But
taking some time to explore
documentation can be a quick way
to find your answer, you'll want
to learn how to search a webpage
with Command F or Control F.
That way, you can look for
specific keywords on a page, or
hopefully they have a good
search bar that works well.
Sometimes documentation can be
really dense. So maybe you'll
move to the next step, which is
doing a web search. At the end
of the day, good software
engineers are secretly just
professional Googlers. And this
is one of their most powerful
tools, being able to search the
web for somebody else who has
already run into the problem
that you've just run into, and
then solved it. Most search
engines like Google have tools
you can use to get even more
specific about what you're
looking for. Often for specific
errors, the best thing to do is
actually just copy the exact
error and paste it in the search
bar with quotes or use the
Asterix in spots, your error
might be too specific. Most of
the results you'll get will be
from forums and q&a sites, which
leads us to our next step,
asking questions in these forums
and q&a sites. Just make sure
that before you ask a question,
you've done some ample Googling
around yourself beforehand. This
way you don't waste yours and
anybody else's time. And by
asking questions that you swear
you will promise me that at some
point, you will go back and help
other people learn as well got
it good. Before even asking your
question though, we should learn
where is going to be the best
place to ask. This is why I've
categorized for different types
of forums and QA sites, feel
free to pause to read them over.
And here's some specific
examples of each one of these
index code base forms like Stack
Overflow, index repositories
like GitHub issues, index
technology, specific forums,
like our slash eat dev or
unindexed discussion platforms
like chainlink discord, one of
the key differentiators in these
categories is the index keyword.
We typically want to ask
questions on forums that web
crawlers have gone through and
stuck them in their database or
index them this way. And three
weeks when we look back at the
code that we wrote, we can just
Google what was going on when we
forget what it does. And this
will help out other developers
who run into the same problem,
which in turn, they might go
ahead and help you out later.
Ideally, most of your questions
should be asked on one of these
index forms for this reason for
their searchability and
discoverability. However, at
some questions are a better fit
for DMS, Twitter or discord that
aren't index and we made a
little chart here to figure out
where's the best place to post
your questions, feel free to
pause the video take a look or
read our blog and the
descriptions with the picture as
well to take another look at it.
And of course, before actually
posting that in one of these
forums, be sure to read their
rules as they might state that
some kind of questions are
specifically for Ben. But
basically the breakdown looks
like this. Theoretical big
picture or opinionated questions
can go great on general q&a
forums like Quora or specific
technical forums like specific
subreddits or discord forums,
specific coding questions can go
on these forums as well, but
will often get more eyes on
coding forums like Stack
Overflow or Stack Exchange
communities often the question
of Oh, should I post this on
stack URL? flow or maybe a Stack
Exchange community is incredibly
blurry. And sometimes it doesn't
really matter which one you post
on. Now, if you run into a bug
or an issue with a technology
you're really familiar with, and
you think it shouldn't be
breaking, this is your chance to
pop an issue into their open
source code repository and
potentially improve the tool.
They don't have an open source
code repository, you throw that
closed source piece of shit into
the garbage, but just kidding
closed source Tech has its place
in our lives, too. Additionally,
if you're following a tutorial,
and they have a Git repo
associated with it, like all of
my videos that do, that's gonna
be the best place to leave your
issues. So as much as I hate to
say it, putting your issues onto
my GitHub repositories is going
to be much more effective for us
answering your questions than
posting it in the YouTube
comments. Now finally, Discord,
element, email, text message or
any other these unindexed chats
are still good places to ask
questions, but please try to use
them as a last resort. And if
they do end up answering one of
your questions, maybe go back
and add that question and answer
to one of the other forums that
we were talking about this way
it will be indexed next time you
or somebody else, Google's it
now these quicker chat forums
are places more for the
community to congregate and have
quick conversations with each
other. They're places to theory
craft, talk about new things
coming out new ideas, events,
and other things that shouldn't
be indexed by web crawlers.
They're also great places to
meet and network with people
that you might be able to bounce
ideas off directly as you get to
know each other, which leads
into our last section. But
before we do that, Oh, do you
hear that? Oh, that's the video
inside another video alarm
ringing. When you ask a question
in one of these forums, the
better you format your
questions, the better chance
you'll have of getting an
answered. Now there's no bad
questions out there. But there
are poorly formatted questions.
So let's teach you how to always
ask questions as format as best
as possible to give you the
highest chance of making sure
they get answered. Number one,
before asking your question,
make sure you followed all the
steps in the parent video. And
you've done some research on
this already and make sure the
question hasn't already been
asked. Number two, make a title
that summarizes the specifics of
the question three introduced
the problem before you write any
code, add minimalistic,
reproducible code minimalistic
code means it's not just a copy
paste your entire file. If
you're having problems on one
line, maybe just post that one
line reproducible code means
that others should be able to
run to the exact same error that
you're running into, or at least
post the steps for them to do
it. This doesn't mean that you
should put I was following along
Patrick's video and on our five
I ran into this problem, just
watch his video and you'll get
there. As flattering as this is
it's not reasonable that
everyone is going to have
watched my videos, even though
they should you want to give the
technical steps to reach the
error that you've reached. For
those of you watching my Free
Code Camp video, you're kind of
exempt from this, but you can
only say, Hey, I was on our Five
on this part of your video
inside of our discussions tab of
the GitHub repo associated with
this course. So you can do that.
But only in that GitHub repo
associated with this course,
learning markdown to format your
code, especially using these
three backticks and labeling of
the language. This is a critical
piece of formatting your code
and will drastically improve on
the number of people who answer
your questions. Any errors or
code should be formatted with
this three backticks syntax. And
finally, often people who care
about certain technologies,
monitor specific tags and
monitor specific questions being
asked about the technologies
that they like. And then
finally, again, be sure to read
the forum's guides before
posting different forums have
different rules about what they
want and what they don't want.
So being familiar will increase
your chances of getting an
answer. All right. So now back
to the main video. Now a note
about Stack Overflow, in
particular, Stack Overflow can
be a little aggressive, which is
why sometimes posting on
specific community forums might
be better for your specific
technology questions. If you
post on Stack Overflow, and you
get a ton of down votes on your
questions. Don't let that bother
you. Just take it as a learning
opportunity to learn about what
Stack Overflow likes and doesn't
like and just keep going but do
not let that discourage you.
Okay, well, now that we know
where things should go, where
questions should go and how to
actually format them. Let's
practice let's look at some
sample questions that you might
have. And we'll figure out where
we want to put them. So the
first one, where does this one
go? Feel free to pause and guess
yourself. So a question like
this is going to be great for a
Reddit or a discord? Probably
more a discord. Now, this is
definitely something that you
can search for. Right? So you
probably could search for this,
find an answer and go from
there. But maybe you want to ask
a buddy or maybe you want to ask
a very specific community like
our slash eat Dev. Now, of
course, if you see this
question, you obviously want to
recommend Patrick Collins his
YouTube channel. Now how about
this question. Notice its
formatting right? The title is
nice and big. They have a
technical command that is
formatted properly. They have
Git commit which is formatted
properly, where would this go
like this would definitely do
very well on a Stack Overflow or
an index code based forum to
very clearly try had to do
something technical. The problem
is laid out very clearly. And
they've given the command that
they're looking to do. Now, how
about this one, something like
this could go on either
StackOverflow. But it's probably
more likely going to go on a
GitHub issue for this brownie
package. A big difference
between code forums and and Git
repos like GitHub is that when
you make an issue on a GitHub
repository, especially when you
think there's a problem, you do
want to be as in depth as
possible. So oftentimes, when
making an issue on these repos,
they'll even ask, what version
are you using? Can you post all
your code? Can you post all your
files and just be much, much
more explicit? So how about
something like this. So this is
going to be really good for the
GitHub repo associated with this
tutorial, it looks like this
person is asking about a very
specific tutorial. So posting
this, there is going to be best.
Now if your question is on a
tutorial that doesn't have a
GitHub repo, well, they probably
should. But then maybe this is
better in the comment section.
Now, again, this is where this
all becomes a little bit more
art than science, because maybe
the specific error that they're
running into is a generic error
that a ton of people run into,
and maybe it is better on
StackOverflow. Or maybe there's
an issue with the package. So
maybe it is better on GitHub. Or
maybe the solution to this is
opinionated. And finally, what
about this? Yep, this is going
to be much better for a discord
or a DM with your buddy. And
away, it's our last step on
blocking you from any question
is going to be join and
strengthen the community of your
tool. Now at the start, it's
going to be hard for you to give
back since you're not going to
be very knowledgeable on these
tools. But as you get better at
these technologies, you'll want
to try to answer some of these
new questions that do come in.
The reason is because this will
give you a chance to actually
learn more about the tools that
you like, it'll strengthen the
community of your favorite
tools, meaning if you help
answer questions on tool, it'll
actually encourage other people
to use the tool because there's
a strong following there. And
likely, they might actually help
you sometime in the future, you
helping people will make you
look like a good person. And
then you'll also feel like a
good person. Additionally, in
many forums like Reddit,
oftentimes, mods will actually
look at how often you post
versus how often you help others
and comments on others people
posts and some mods may actually
start blocking your posts for
abusing the forums and not
giving back to the community and
only trying to take knowledge
you in the community will be
more successful if you join in
and help others and not just try
to extract things from other
people. Additionally, by
engaging with the community, I
can't tell you how many people
I've met and I've learned and
been able to brainstorm with.
And then the final step is going
to be iterate through these
steps. Maybe you get to the end
of these and you say, Oh, I'm
still blocked, but you'll likely
be much, much more
knowledgeable. So you want to go
back and try these steps again.
Now this is where this whole
process is a little bit more art
than science. Because some
questions might not have been
discovered yet. Only very few
people know not enough people
understand the importance of the
questions, or maybe people don't
understand your question. And
this is why it's important to go
back and iterate on these steps.
Now that you have the basic
building blocks of this
incredible superpower, I
encourage all of you to go out
there and try this and then let
me know how it went.
Alright, awesome. So now that we
know more about how to get
unblocked, we can move on. The
reason it's so important to
learn how to get unblocked is
because blockchain and web three
is more than just everybody on
their own. It is a very
collaborative space. So as you
get better, and as you learn
more a massive way to test how
much you've learned and give
back to the community is to
going to Stack Overflow and
going to stack exchange them and
trying to answer some questions
yourself. So I highly recommend
you all go to Stack Overflow,
and then you go to the GitHub
repo associated with the scores,
you try to answer some
discussions, try to answer some
issues and help other people out
because it's going to help you
become a much better software
engineer. The other reason I
want to do that part is because
when we install some of the
tools that I'm about to show
you, sometimes the installation
process is the hardest piece
there. Once you get past the
install process, it generally
becomes much, much easier. But
this can often be the hardest
part of the course is just
installing some of these tools
that we're going to give you.
And that's what we're going to
learn about right now. So we
have been working so far with
remix, remix IDE, or integrated
development environment. As
we've seen, it's this wonderful
place where we can try out code
we can try solidity out, we can
compile we can deploy, we can
pretty much do everything that
we need to do. It's web based.
It can do testing, debugging,
deploying local JavaScript VM,
it's very quick and easy to
create and test our smart
contracts. However, it does have
some limitations. It can really
only deal with smart contract,
it can't really integrate with
other parts of projects. It has
limited support for tests or
custom deployments. And you need
an internet connection to even
work with remix and it can be
tricky to do a lot more advanced
functionality. So it's a
phenomenal tool and absolutely
if you're looking to do
something very quickly, I
absolutely recommend everybody
just go to remix to go ahead and
try something out how are now
we're going to move over to a
more professional smart contract
developer setup. And this is
with hard hat. This is known as
a smart contract developer
framework similar to brownie or
foundry or, and likes, there's a
number of these frameworks. And
the reason that we're going to
do hard hat is because hard hat
is JavaScript based. It's a
JavaScript based development
environment. It's got JavaScript
based compilation, environment,
deploying, testing, debugging.
Now, for those of you who love
TypeScript, we will also have
TypeScript editions of every
single one of our code examples
for you. So if you love
JavaScript, we got you, if you
love TypeScript, we also got you
we're not always going to walk
through us doing the TypeScript.
But we will sometimes, and all
of the code for the TypeScript
will be available in the GitHub
repo. Now, before we can
actually learn hard hat, we have
to learn another package first.
So we're going to learn how to
do everything with ethers. Jas,
which is a JavaScript based
library for working with smart
contracts. And it's also what
powers the next tool that we're
going to be working with, which
is hard hat under the hood of
hard hat. There's a lot of
ethers Jas. So it's important
for us to learn ethers Jas so
that we can understand what hard
hat is actually doing. Now for
the rest of the course, I'm
going to be using a code editor
called Visual Studio code. This
is one of the most powerful code
editors on the planet. And if
you've already got it set up,
feel free to go ahead and skip
this part. If you already have a
professional coding setup with
no GS and VS code, and Git and
everything, feel free to use the
timestamps in the GitHub
repository. To skip over this
setup section. You'll often hear
people refer to this as VS code,
or Visual Studio code or just
Visual Studio. However, it's
important to note that Visual
Studio code this is different
than Visual Studio, which you
might see look like this. So
Visual Studio code is what you
want, not Visual Studio, Visual
Studio is a different
application, make sure you're on
Visual Studio code. Now, if you
choose so and you're a total
Harto, you can absolutely work
just with your terminal, or just
with PowerShell, or just with
whatever coding environment that
you want, like atom or Sublime.
However, for us, we're going to
be working with Visual Studio
code. And I'm going to be going
through setting up Visual Studio
code the way that I like to set
it up, you can actually set it
up whatever way that you feel
comfortable. And of course, in
our lesson six here, we have a
link to installation and setup.
And I'm going to be adding more
links as we go about here. And
once again, all the code that
we're going to be working with
is in this GitHub repository
down here where it says code.
Now we're gonna go through three
different installation processes
and pick the one that's most
appropriate for you. The first
one is going to be for Mac and
Linux users. The second one is
going to be for Windows users.
And then our third one is going
to be a last ditch effort. If
for whatever reason, you can't
get Windows or Linux or the Mac
instructions to work, we're
going to use a Git pod
installation. Now, I highly,
highly recommend that you try to
get everything working locally
without using Git pod. However,
if for whatever reason, you
can't get those installation
pieces to work, we will have Git
pod instructions for all of the
repos that we work with here.
But to get started, we'll start
with the Mac and Linux
installation instructions.
The first thing you're going to
want to do is download the Mac
or if you're working with Linux,
download the Linux installation
of Visual Studio code. Once you
have it installed, it'll look a
little something like this. And
if it's a fresh installation,
It'll even give you some tips
and tools to actually get
started. If you've never worked
with Visual Studio code before,
I highly recommend going through
any get started or getting
instructions tips that come with
opening Visual Studio Code.
Additionally, we have a Visual
Studio Code crash course in the
GitHub repo associated with this
course. Once you have Visual
Studio code installed, the next
thing that we're going to want
to install is going to be node j
s. And again, we have links to
all of these in the GitHub repo
associated with this course, you
can just go ahead and click
download for Mac OS or download
for Linux, I recommend using the
LTS version. lts stands for long
term support, which means that
they will be supporting this
version for a long time. So go
ahead and download Node js. I've
already downloaded this, so I'm
not gonna go ahead and
redownload this now one of the
awesome things about Visual
Studio code is it has this thing
called terminals, which are
command line prompts that allow
us to run scripts, basically,
it's where we're going to be
running all of our code where we
can open up the terminal is we
can go ahead and hit terminal
and select new terminal and
you'll get something like this.
Now you might have bash or Z ca
or some other type of shell type
that you have doesn't really
matter because on Mac and Linux
it's going to be Linux based we
can now test our no Jess
installation has been done
correctly by running Node dash
dash version, and you should see
something that looks like this.
The exact version of node that
you have doesn't really matter
here. But ideally you're at
least on Node version 14 or
higher. And if something like
this doesn't show up, remember
to go ahead and start looking at
Stack Overflow looking on the
GitHub repo in the discussions
tab, looking on the updated
section, etc. And like I said,
sometimes installing this can be
the hardest part of this entire
course so, so don't get
discouraged. And please use
Stack Overflow Stack Exchange
Etherium, and the GitHub repo to
move past any issues you run
into. Now, if you're on Mac or
Linux, you can actually hit Ctrl
back tick, to actually toggle
your terminal mode, this will
pull the terminal up and down
for you getting familiar with
keyboard shortcuts will actually
make your life a lot easier.
Because you'll be able to move
around Visual Studio code much
more effectively, we have a link
to a list of keyboard shortcuts.
Additionally, in the GitHub
repository associated with this
section, as we move along, I'll
give tip on different keyboard
shortcuts that you can
optionally use otherwise, you
can just go ahead and click as
well, you can click the trash
can to delete the terminal, go
back up Terminal new terminal to
pop it back up. Now the next
thing that we're going to need a
little bit later, we're not
going to need it for this
section, but it's good to
install it now is going to be
git no jazz is known as a
JavaScript runtime. And it's a
tool that we're going to use to
help run JavaScript code in our
Visual Studio Code slot exactly
JavaScript. And the difference
between no Jas and JavaScript
can be a little bit confusing,
but don't let that stop you for
now. Next, we're actually going
to go ahead and install Git, we
will have links to the
installation instructions in the
GitHub repository, installing
git on Linux, you're going to
use one of these two commands
and on macOS, if you just type
git on the command line, it
should go ahead and prompt you
to install it. So we're back in
our command line, and we just
type git, it should prompt you
to go ahead and stall it. And if
you do get dash dash version,
you should get something that
looks like this. You can also
use a Mac OS get installer by
clicking this link here and
running through the installation
process. Alright, now that you
have no JS yet in Visual Studio
code installed, we can continue
on to the next section. Awesome.
If you're not planning on using
Windows or get pod, feel free to
skip the next two sections.
I'm running this on Windows 11.
However, it should work on most
editions of Windows. So the
first thing that we're going to
want to install is Visual Studio
Code, which looks something like
this, it should auto detect it.
And we're gonna go ahead and
download this for windows in a
walk through all the
installation process. Go ahead
and create a desktop item, we'll
add this just in case we want to
open with code. And we'll go
ahead and install. And then
we'll go ahead and finish. Once
you've installed Visual Studio
code, you'll see something that
looks a little like this, it'll
go ahead and give you this get
started with VS Code section
where you can choose some
themes, and you can choose kind
of the way it looks feel free to
customize it the way that you
want. If you want to learn a
little bit more about Visual
Studio code, I highly recommend
you walk through this section to
learn more about the shortcuts
and making your development
experience more efficient. When
you're done, you can just go
ahead and close the tabs at the
top. And it'll look a little
something like this. Once we
have Visual Studio code
installed. The next thing that
we're going to want to install
is node j s. And of course, we
have a link to installing this
in the GitHub repository
associated with this course,
what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and come to
node j s.org. To download this
for Windows node. JS is a
JavaScript runtime environment,
it's not exactly JavaScript. And
the distinction can be a little
bit confusing, but just know
it's going to help us run our
JavaScript code for our
development environment. Let's
go ahead and download the LTS or
the long term support edition of
no GS. We'll go ahead and we'll
run through the setup wizard.
And we'll go ahead and make sure
that this is clicked just in
case we ever want to use some
different tools with our setup.
And then we'll go ahead and
click Install, you'll get a pop
up asking if you really want to
install this on your device. And
we'll go ahead and hit yes. And
then we'll hit finish, you might
get a pop up that looks like
this, go ahead and click any
button to go ahead and install
the tools, go ahead and press
any key again. And you'll likely
get a Windows PowerShell screen
pop up asking you to go ahead
and install a whole bunch of
different projects and files. If
you chose not to install this,
that's totally okay. But in the
future, this will be really
helpful since we are going to
use a lot of tools that this
package installs anyways, this
might take some time to install.
So go ahead and be patient. And
if it gets stuck, it might just
be waiting for you to go ahead
and hit enter. So go ahead and
hit Enter for any prompts. But
yes, please be patient with
this, it can be a little bit
slow to go ahead and install
everything. Once you have all
that installed, you can come
back to Visual Studio code. And
we're going to go ahead and open
up a terminal. To do that we hit
terminal and we hit new terminal
terminal is going to be our
command line prompt where we're
going to basically run all of
our scripts to work with our
code. And if you run Node dash
dash version, you should see
something that looks like this
to know that you've installed
Node js correctly. Now this
command line is known as Windows
PowerShell. If you want to work
with Windows PowerShell, you
absolutely can. In fact, if you
want to be a total Harto, and
write all your code through
Windows PowerShell, you can
absolutely do that as well.
However, we're actually not
going to be working with
PowerShell We're going to be
using a tool that makes our
Windows environments more like
Linux. The reason that we're
doing this is Linux is the
standard for most development
environments. And having
everybody work on a very similar
setup will make the rest of this
course a lot easier for everyone
to interact with each other, no
matter what coding environment,
they're working on. WsL stands
for Windows subsystem for Linux,
and allows Linux programs to run
natively on our Windows
environments. To get this setup,
we're gonna go ahead, go to the
WsL install. And we'll have a
link for this as well in our
GitHub repository. So what we're
going to do, you must be running
a Windows 10, version 2004 or
higher, or Windows 11. If you're
using an older version of
Windows, you can absolutely
continue with PowerShell. But
you might run into some issues
where all the commands don't
work exactly the same. So I
highly recommend working on a
newer version of Windows. To
install this back in your Visual
Studio Code, PowerShell, or just
the PowerShell app, or running
WsL dash dash install. Now if
you get this error, the
requested operation requires
elevation, it means that we have
to run our Visual Studio code or
our PowerShell application as
administrator. We close out our
Visual Studio code. And right
click it and say, Run as
Administrator, we get a little
pop up saying Do you want to
allow this app to make changes
to your device, we'll go ahead
and click Yes. And then we'll
reopen the terminal. And then we
can run WsL space dash dash
install. And we'll go ahead and
install WsL. This may take a
little bit so please be patient.
Once it's completed, you'll see
something that looks like this,
we're going to be working with
Ubuntu. And we have a list of
different commands to change
your Linux distribution. If you
choose to do so. And you'll see
the request set operation is
successful changes will not be
effective until the system is
rebooted. So you'll want to go
ahead and restart your computer.
There's also a troubleshooting
guide in the GitHub repository.
If you run into issues after you
restart your computer, you'll be
prompted for a name for your new
system and a password. This can
be different from your Windows
name and password, and then just
follow through with all the
prompts. And then once you're
done, you'll be dropped into a
Ubuntu shell, and you can run
Linux commands. Now you'll have
a Ubuntu instance, on your
machine. And you'll be able to
run Linux commands in your
terminal. Now that we have WsL
set up correctly, we're going to
head back over to Visual Studio
code. Once we have WsL, we'll
want to go ahead and install an
extension. So in our Visual
Studio code, we'll go to
Extensions, and we'll look up
remote development you can
install the whole thing or just
remote WsL we're gonna install
the whole thing you can follow
along to get started with remote
WsL if you like, or you can just
follow along with me right now.
Right now if I go to the
terminal and hit new terminal,
I'm still gonna get PowerShell
we actually want this to be our
Linux shell. So there are a
couple ways to open Visual
Studio code up in our Linux
environment. One way is you're
gonna hit Ctrl, Shift P and type
WsL. And then click remote WsL
new WsL window, and you'll get a
new window that looks like this,
you can also click the bottom
left and choose New WsL window.
Now if we go to our terminal and
hit new terminal, we'll be
dropped into a bash shell and we
can run Linux commands in here.
Awesome. Another way we can open
up Visual Studio code with WsL
on is we can go into our your
boon to application, we can make
a folder by typing MK dir
folder, we'll CD or change
directory into folder and type
code period. We'll go ahead and
trust the authors in here. And
this will open up Visual Studio
code already connected to the
folder that we're in. And we can
create files in this folder like
hi dot txt, and those will get
created inside the folder in our
WsL. Now that we're inside our
WsL environment, you'll notice
that node dash dash version
doesn't work anymore. That's
because we installed it on our
regular Windows machine and not
on our WsL or Linux environment.
The reason we installed it on a
Windows environment first is
that just in case you wanted to
go ahead and use PowerShell or
user Windows environment to run
everything you still can just
remember if you use the Windows
environment and PowerShell all
the commands that we use might
not work for you. So we're gonna
go ahead and install Node js on
our Linux environment. Now, all
the commands that we're going to
write are going to be in the
GitHub repo associated with this
course. We're going to do a curl
command to the nvm repository,
which stands for node version
manager.
And we're going to pipe the
install script into bash. And
this will go ahead and install
and VM. After running that, go
ahead and trash the terminal,
and then reopen it. And then we
can type MBM dash dash version
to see if it actually installed
correctly. Once we've installed
nvm, we can go ahead and install
no GS using nvm. Just type npm
install, and we'll do 16 point
14.2 Is that same long term
support version we installed on
our Windows machine. Once we
have it installed, we can type
in Node dash S version. And now
we have no JS installed. Now I
know there was a lot here, but
if you made it this far, this is
fantastic. You've done a great
job to push through to this
point and get everything set up
so you can code in the best
environment there is. So if
you've made it this far, huge
congratulations. Now the next
thing that we're going to
install is Git. And now we're
not going to use Git for this
lesson. However, we will
definitely be using it in the
future. See if gets installed
type git dash dash version,
sometimes Linux will
automatically come with Git
installed and you'll see
something output like this. If
you don't have Git, we can just
look up the get install. Which
again, link to this is in the
description. And you'll actually
run the installing on Linux. Now
again, now if you want to use
PowerShell, and you want to do
everything with Windows, you can
absolutely follow the installing
on Windows instructions here
instead, when you're working in
WsL, you'll want to use the
Linux commands instead of the
windows commands even though
you're on a Windows because WsL
makes it so that you're
basically running in a Linux
environment. And now if you've
made it this far, you should be
able to follow along with the
Mac and Linux instructions as if
you're running on a Mac and
Linux even though you're running
on Windows. Just be sure that
whenever you're in your VS code,
you take a look at the bottom
left and make sure you're on WsL
Ubuntu. Like I said before, if
you want to run in PowerShell,
or in a Windows environment,
you're more than free to do so.
But like I said, if you've made
it this far, huge
congratulations. Awesome work.
And then finally, our last setup
is going to be using a tool
called Git pod starting from
Lesson five. The lesson that
we're on right now, ethers,
jazz, simple storage, all of our
code repos are going to come
with a button in the repo scroll
down, they'll come with this
open in get pod button. Now git
pod is a cloud development
environment where you can
actually run your code on a
remote server, it's kind of
similar to remix IDE, but it
allows you to run Visual Studio
code in the browser or connected
to another server. This is good
because then you don't have to
do any installation on anything.
Since all the tools that you can
want to use are just going to be
running on this remote server.
This has its downsides, though,
obviously, since you'll only be
able to code if git pod is up
and working for you.
Additionally, when it comes to
private keys, you absolutely do
not want to run any code with a
private key that has real money
in good pop. Why? Well, once
again, since you're running your
scripts on a remote server,
those servers have access to
your private keys. But since
you've Pinky promise that for
this course, you're not going to
be using a meta mask or a
private key with actual money in
it, it should be fine. The other
downside is that these often
cost money to use and get pot
isn't free. But it's an option
if you absolutely cannot get any
of the installation working. So
if you go ahead and you hit this
opening get pod button, you'll
get a welcome to get pods
showing up. We're gonna go ahead
and continue with GitHub. Since
you've signed up for GitHub
here, you want to go ahead and
authorize get pod. And it'll go
ahead and start creating this
workspace for you. And you'll
notice it looks exactly like
Visual Studio Code. Since I
opened the repo up in Git pod,
it came with all the code, and
you can even open this workspace
up in VS code desktop. So this
is might be a little bit
confusing. But basically, you
can run off of Git pod using
your local Visual Studio code.
And if you see git pod here,
that's how you know that you're
running off of Git pod. If you
see this pop up, do you want to
open this workspace in VS code
desktop, you can hit Open. And
it'll ask you if you want to
open up Visual Studio Code,
which I'm going to go ahead and
hit yes. And you'll get
something that looks like this
on your Visual Studio Code.
It'll tell you that it wants to
install the Git pod extension,
and then open that Git pod URL.
So you can go ahead and install
it. Reload window and open and
it's going to go ahead and start
connecting to our the Git pod
workspace. And this is going to
be the same as running git pod
in the browser here. Or you can
also do it manually by hitting
the Git pod in the bottom left,
and then type in open in VS code
And then you should be able to
run it in your Visual Studio
code. For now, I'm going to
recommend that if you're using
Git pod, just stay in the
browser, just so that you know,
okay, I am running this on a
remote server. And just as a
reminder for you that you're not
actually locally developing. And
hopefully, this will be a
trigger to not actually put any
special private keys or anything
like that. But you can make
workspaces, you can make new
folders, and you should be able
to run all the commands on here,
as if you are running locally
with Visual Studio code. To open
up the terminal, you can hit
this little bar at the top left,
go to terminal, new terminal, or
use CTRL tilde exact same as Mac
OS and Linux keyboard shortcuts
to create a new folder, we can
change directory, CD, dot.mk,
dir, new folder, MK dir makes
make directory called New
Folder. And then we're going to
change our directory into a new
folder, and hit enter. And now
we're in that new folder. For
each section, you can either
open up the entire source code
right into GitHub, or you can
create a new folder for each
section yourself and start from
blank. And then you would just
type code period. And you'd be
in a brand new folder. All
right, this is fantastic. At
this point, you should be set up
with Visual Studio Code no Jas
and get. And I'm going to be
working out of a folder called
Hard Hat Free Code Camp at this
point, you should have node,
dash dash version, get dash dash
version. And if you're using
Windows, this should say WsL or
your boon to or something like
that. And if you have all that,
that means we're ready to go.
Now a quick note something that
you'll see me do a lot. And you
can do this as well. Oftentimes,
when my terminal gets really,
really big, or there's a ton of
commands in here gets a little
bit overwhelming for me. So one
thing that you can do is you can
type clear, and hit Enter to
clear it. Or what you can do is
you can hit Command K, if you're
on a Mac, or Ctrl K, if you're
on a Linux or a Windows, and
it's one of my favorite keyboard
shortcuts that I use all the
time. Additionally, the trash
can and the X here are very
different. If I go to a couple
of enters here, and we're down
here, if I hit the trashcan, and
then pull my terminal back up,
by doing the toggle, or by doing
terminal new terminal, you'll
see all those lines are still
here. But if I hit the trashcan,
and then pull the terminal back
up, you'll see it actually
refreshes mine a special command
that prints stuff out. trashing
your terminal is basically
deleting whatever's running in
it, and the x is just hiding it.
And as hitting Ctrl tilde or
toggling our terminal or
whatever command it is on your
environment, that's equivalent
to hitting the hide, not the
trash. So if we want to remove
and start a terminal over, we
hit the trashcan, and then we
pull it back up. Alright, so now
we're gonna start working with
ethers. And we're going to start
learning to code, our
transactions and our contract
deployments and everything
programmatically at a relatively
low level. And we're gonna learn
how to deploy and interact with
the contracts using the ethers
JS package. Now to get started,
I'm going to recommend you
create a folder where you're
going to put all of your
projects in it, I'm going to
create a new directory called H
H. hyphen, FCC, which stands for
hard hat Free Code Camp. And
once we run that command, we can
cd into hh FCC. And this is
where we'll create all of our
projects for this course moving
forward, so that we have them
all in one place. Now to get
started, whenever you create a
new project, you always want to
create a new folder. So to
create a new folder, we're going
to do MK dir, and we're going to
call this ethers, simple
storage, like that. And now, if
you type ls, you'll see that
there is one folder named
ethers, simple storage. ls is
how you list all the contents of
your folder. You might have a
lot of other folders in here, I
only have the one since I
created this new folder for
this. Now what you can do, you
can type code, ethers simple.
And then if you hit tab, it
should autocomplete for you. And
if you enter, Visual Studio code
should open up a new Visual
Studio code for you. That is
inside of either simple storage
if you open up your terminal
now, your home directory for
this workspace is going to be
through simple storage as this
is what pops up. If that doesn't
work for you, we can also do is
you can hit File, Open folder
and then open the folder that
you just created or that you
want to open this again we'll
open up VS code. And if we open
up our terminal we see we're
inside of ether simple storage.
This is so powerful because as
we create files
we'll be able to See those files
in our Explorer here, this
button here stands for the
Explorer. If we click it, we can
see the different files in here.
And I'm going to go ahead and
actually delete this file dot
txt, because we're not actually
going to use that. Now it's this
part of the course, where we're
actually going to start jumping
into some JavaScript. Since this
course is in JavaScript course,
if you're unfamiliar with
JavaScript, it might be a little
bit tricky. If you want to come
into this with a better
understanding of JavaScript and
Node js, there is a Free Code
Camp YouTube video teaching No,
Jas for beginners. And a link to
this will be in the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
There's also a JavaScript Free
Code Camp video that I'm also
going to put in the description
for this course, keep in mind
that JavaScript and Node js are
slightly different. And we are
going to go over some of the
differences as we code along
here. But for the most part,
learning one means you've
learned the majority of the
other. So if you want to pause
and go through these videos,
before continuing here, please
feel free to do so you don't
have to, you can absolutely
continue on with the course as
is. And if you get confused or
stuck on some JavaScript piece,
feel free to pause, Google it
and come back. But just to
reiterate, you can check out the
JavaScript programming full
course. And also the Node js
full course, as those are both
going to help you. Like I was
saying before, Node js is a
JavaScript runtime. So it's not
exactly JavaScript. But we're
going to write our code in
JavaScript. And if that's
confusing, just don't worry
about it right now. And as we go
through this course, I'll show
you where the differences are.
But basically, you can think of
no Jas and JavaScript kind of
being the same thing. The big
thing about Node js is it allows
us to write JavaScript code in
the back end, as opposed to
running JavaScript on the front
end, JavaScript is made to be a
browser run language, like
running inside of, you know,
Chrome, brave Firefox, etc. No,
Jas allows it to become a a
scripting language, a back end
language, which is why the
syntax between the front end
JavaScript and the back end
JavaScript or the no JS
JavaScript are going to be a
little bit different.
Additionally, as we go along in
this code, if you're familiar
with TypeScript, all of our code
is going to come with a
TypeScript edition. TypeScript
is what's known as a statically
typed version of JavaScript. And
it'll be it'll be this one.
It'll be TypeScript, not
TypeScript edition. I'll go
ahead and fix that and remove
this one to make it clear.
TypeScript is a type safe
version of JavaScript, which is
that's confusing, don't worry
too much about that. But we are
going to do all of our
programming in JavaScript. And
then if the code is different
enough, I'll show you how to do
it in TypeScript as well.
However, for most of them, we're
not going to show you the
TypeScript editions, because
it's going to be really similar.
But you can always refer back to
the GitHub repository to see all
the code for the TypeScript.
Now, if you're new to this
space, I actually do recommend
you go ahead and start with
JavaScript and learn how to do
TypeScript later on. TypeScript
actually catches bugs early on,
making it a lot easier to code
your projects in the long run.
However, it does take a lot of
extra typing. And it can be a
little bit frustrating learning
how types work for beginners,
JavaScript is a little bit more
loose as a language and lets us
kind of do whatever we want, but
it can cause a headache later
on. So if you do run into some
issues, and you do run into some
bugs, it might be a good idea to
try TypeScript on for size, and
see how that fares. Well. Let's
go ahead and begin working on
our local development
environment and getting set up
to do everything in ethers Jas
and in JavaScript. Oops. And I
actually went and renamed this
folder to ether symbol storage
dash, FCC. Reason I added this
dash FCC is all the GitHub
repositories associated with
this course, all the GitHub
repos that have this dash FCC to
know that it is part of this
hard hat JavaScript course.
Awesome. Let's jump in. Let's
start working with solidity and
our smart contracts locally in
Visual Studio code, as you can
probably tell by the name of
this folder. And of course, if
you looked at the code, this
project is going to be our
simple storage project, but
developed locally using ethers.
So the first thing that we want
to do is want to get in that
smart contract code. So what we
can do is make sure we have the
Explorer selected, we can go
ahead and right click and select
new file and do simple storage.
So just close this for now. And
we can copy paste our simple
storage code from our last
section into VS code.
If you closed remix or you
forgot where it is, you can just
go to the ethers simple storage
FCC repo, it's simple storage
dot Sol, and we can just copy
all the code in here and then
come back over select Symbol
storage that Saul and paste it
in. Now an important note about
Visual Studio code is that when
you see this little white.up
here, it means that this file
isn't saved to save your Git
file. To save, and it'll go away
like that. Or what you can do is
you can hit command S or Ctrl S,
depending on if you're on a
Windows, Mac, or Linux. Now
you'll see here that this code
is a little bit hard to read the
simple storage dot salt, it
doesn't have the syntax
highlighting that we saw in
remix. So we want to go ahead
and add a Visual Studio Code
extension to give this syntax
highlighting. So what we can do
is come over to this bar over
here looks like this. And if you
don't see it on the left hand
bar, you should click these
three dots, and it should be in
here. But we'll go ahead and
click Extensions. And what we're
going to do is we're going to
look up, solidity plus hard hat.
And we're going to install this
solidity plus hard hat
extension. For VS code. Now that
we have this installed, if we go
back over to our simple storage
dot sole, you'll see that all
the highlighting is back in. And
now it's much easier to read.
Right? So this is good. We have
our code in here we have our
syntax highlighting. Now let's
add an auto format or or default
format or right now our code is
pretty good with the way that
it's formatted. But what if we,
we accidentally do some stuff
like this or like this, or maybe
even like this, we add a ton of
new lines, etc, our code can
start to look pretty gross. And
even though the code itself is
fine, and it'll run the exact
same way, with all this extra
whitespace, it doesn't look very
good, right. And due to that, it
can be a little bit hard to
read. What we want to do, then,
we want to open up our settings
and adjust our vias code so that
it auto formats whenever we
save, so whenever we save, so
that whenever it goes from the
little white dot here to no
white dot, this whole thing gets
automatically formatted to some
looks really nice. Okay. So what
we can do is we can open up our
command palette to open up our
command palette, you can hit
View command palette, and we'll
get a little pop up that looks
like this. Another way to open
up your command palette is
you're gonna hit Command, Shift
P, or Ctrl, Shift P, depending
on your Mac, or Linux or
Windows. And what we want to do
is we want to type in settings,
and we're going to open Settings
JSON, we don't want to open the
default settings JSON. We don't
want to touch these. But we want
to open our JSON settings.
You'll also notice there are
user settings and workspace
settings. These are pieces that
we can adjust as well. But we're
going to just go right into the
JSON settings. So So I already
have some stuff in here, but
yours might be blank. Or you
might have some stuff in here as
well. So what we're going to do
is if you have stuff in here
already, we're going to add a
comma, then we're going to do
quotes, solidity. Close the
brackets, we're gonna do a
little colon and something like
this. This means that we're
going to apply some settings to
our Visual Studio Code. Whenever
we're working with solidity, one
of the things we're going to add
in here is going to be an
editor, Doc's default, for
matter. And you might even get a
pop up that tells you some
different things that we can use
for a default format or our
default format, or is going to
be Nanak, foundation, dot hard
hat, hyphens solidity. This will
mean that any time we go to
format our code, it'll use the
hard hat solidity plug in, as
its default format, or the hard
hat solidity plugin comes with
some formatting, and a lot of
other really useful tools for us
writing our code. So now that we
have this part in, the next
thing we're going to do is add
format on Save. If we haven't
already, we could add it in here
in our JSON, but I'm going to
add it not in the JSON file, I'm
going to add it in the overall
file. So if we open that command
palette back up, and we type in
settings, open user settings,
this is another really good
place where we can look in add
settings with the UI. So these
two do essentially the same
thing. It's just that this one
has dials and a little bit more
context versus settings that
JSON just says Okay, give me the
raw code for it. This tells us a
little bit more. So you can use
either one. But we're going to
look for format, on save. And
you're going to want this
checked if you haven't already.
This means that every time we
save VS code is going to try to
format our code for us. So now
that we have this checked, we
have settings dot JSON added in.
And remember, we want to save
this. Remember, if you see this
white dot, that means not saved.
So you're gonna want to save it
and close it out. Let me close
this out too. If we come back in
here and we add a bunch of
random new spaces or whatever,
you want to make it look a
little bit ugly, and then we
save it. It should automatically
reformat to look much nicer,
right. So if we do something
like this, we'd save it
reformats it to look much nicer
this one make them more readable
for you, and more readable for
anybody else who looks at your
code. And it's just really nice.
And this line of code for your
settings dot JSON is located in
the full blockchain study
course.js. So you can also just
copy paste it, we are going to
end up overriding that default
format or with another format
are called prettier pretty soon.
But it's great to have a default
format or so that if you don't
feel like adding the prettier
code sometime in the future, you
can just rely on your default
formatter. Awesome. While we're
doing formatting, let's also add
a default format or for our
JavaScript code. And just to
test it out, let's go ahead and
create our new file, we'll call
it deploy dot Jas. And in here,
we can do something like
function Hi,
console dot log, hi, and then
just add and then just make it
look kind of gross, maybe
something like this. If you hit
save, and it does some auto
formatting, that's great, you
can actually turn that off by
going back to your command
palette, and saying, Save
without formatting. And that way
it will be saved and not
formatted. The way we can add
some other formatting here is
we're gonna install another
extension, this one is going to
be called prettier. So we can
just look up prettier and
extensions here. And you'll want
to install this prettier code
formatter. So we're gonna go
ahead and install this. And
great, now it's installed
prettier is a form is a code
format, or that works for many
languages like Python,
JavaScript, and even solidity.
And pretty soon we're going to
use prettier for both JavaScript
and solidity. But for now, we're
just going to use prettier for
JavaScript, we can enable this
by opening back up our command
palette, we'll go to
preferences, open Settings. And
the same way we added a solidity
section, we're going to add a
JavaScript section. So we're
going to add a comma here, some
quotes, brackets, we're going to
type in JavaScript, close that
colon brackets. And we're going
to do the same thing at the door
dot default, or matter. Net
we're going to do and then in
here, we're going to do e s
BENP, that prettier, hyphen VS
code. And this will make
prettier the default editor for
JavaScript. Now, like I said,
pretty soon, we're going to have
prettier override both of these
for solidity and JavaScript. And
we're going to give prettier
some parameters so that no
matter who uses your code, they
will always have the exact same
formatting. But now that we have
prettier in here as the default
editor, if we come back to
deploy dot j s, and we hit save,
it should format to look a
little something like this. Now,
we go ahead and we do something
like this. If we go ahead and do
something like this, it'll
reformat to look like look like
that. And then additionally, if
you want to go back to the
command palette, open user
settings, not in JSON mode, and
we go to default format, or you
can actually even select the
default format or for all
languages, if you want to use
prettier for all formatters.
Feel free to go ahead. Alright,
great, got our JavaScript
format, or in as well, let's
start writing some JavaScript
code.
Awesome. So now that we have our
code in here, it's time for us
to learn how to actually deploy
our contract using JavaScript.
This is going to teach us a lot
about transactions and what's
going on under the hood, and
even what's going on under the
hood in remix, and remix, we
usually just hit a compile
button, and then hit a Deploy
button. And that's really it. In
JavaScript, we're actually going
to create our own functions that
are going to help us do both of
those. And as I mentioned, this
is the part of the course we're
going to start working with
JavaScript, and optionally,
TypeScript if you like. Like I
said, all of these sections come
with a TypeScript edition as
well. So let's set up our
deployed out js script to
actually deploy our simple
storage dot soul. So how can we
get started here? Well, let's
first learn how to run a script
using JavaScript and Node J S.
So if you want to do a print
line, or just print something
out to your terminal, we can do
something called a console dot
log. And if I do console dot
log, hi, I hit Save. And I open
up my terminal. I can now run
Node deploy.js. And it'll print
out high node is how we say hey,
we want to run this JavaScript
code using Node js. Other
languages you might be familiar
with, sometimes we'll do Python,
you know, deployed up py, or
Java, C deploy dot Java, you
know, etc. But with JavaScript,
since the front end and back end
JavaScript are different. We run
code on the back end with node.
And with JavaScript, you can do
a lot of things that you'd see
in something like solidity with
a little bit looser have a
structure. If I wanted to create
some variable, I could say let
variable equals five, this kind
of similar into solidity like
you and 256, variable equals
five. But in JavaScript, we use
let or var or const. And then I
can print this out, I can do
console dot log variable. And I
had saved JavaScript is optional
on whether or not you actually
want to have semicolons. Here, I
think prettier, defaults to
putting semicolons. And we'll
get rid of those in the near
future in your terminal. Once
you start typing the name of a
file, if you hit tab, it could
autocomplete the rest of the
file name for you node deploy
hit Tab, it'll autocomplete and
if we hit enter, now, we get Hi,
and then we get five. Since this
prints out Hi, and then it
prints out five. JavaScript
automatically starts with
whatever code you have at the
top of the file. So it does
console dot log first and
variable. And then this one as
well. However, a good practice
is to actually wrap everything
you want to do in a main
function, and then run that main
function. But what we could do
is up at the top here, we'd say
function, mean, add parentheses
and some brackets, a closing
bracket at the bottom, and hit
save for its auto format. Right
now, if we run this, nothing
will happen, because we've
wrapped all of our code in a
main function. So if I run it
now node deployed to Jess,
nothing happens, because I need
something to call the main
function. So if I then take
this, this main function down
here, and I call main, our jobs
from code is actually going to
say, ah, the first line of the
script is actually this main
function here. So now if I do
node deploy dot j, s, it'll run
high and five, which is what we
want. Now, this is going to be
the setup for most of our
scripts moving forward,
including the scripts that we
write, when we get to hard hat,
however, there is going to be
one major difference. Instead of
regular functions, we're
actually going to use something
called async functions. And
we're going to do something
called asynchronous programming
to do this. Now, if what I say
next is really confusing for you
don't let it slow you down, feel
free to go ahead and watch that
JavaScript course to learn more
about this. But I'll also let
you know, hey, this is an async
function. Here's what we need to
be aware of when working with
it,
okay. But I do want to give you
a quick bit background on
asynchronous programming. So
far, the programming that we've
done has been synchronous. And
solidity is an example of a
programming language, that
synchronous, Synchronous means
it just goes one line after
another. If our code looks like
this, this is synchronous write,
our main function is the first
thing that actually gets called.
Then we do console dot log, that
variable equals five, and then
console dot log. Again, this is
synchronous programming in
JavaScript, all of our solidity
is synchronously programmed.
There will be some exceptions to
this when working with oracles.
But for now, everything is
synchronous. JavaScript can be
asynchronous, meaning that we
can actually have code running
at the same time. A good example
I like to use to understand the
difference is with cooking. In
synchronous programming, for
cooking, you might put popcorn
in microwave, wait for popcorn
to finish. And then, and then
maybe you'll pour drinks for
everyone. And now this is
synchronous programming. Now, it
might be a little bit weird for
you just to put the popcorn in
the microwave, and then just
stare at it, waiting for it to
finish. And then pour the
drinks, you typically can pour
the drinks while your popcorn is
in the microwave. And this is
where asynchronous programming
comes in. If setting up for this
movie night, we're asynchronous,
what you would do is you'd put
popcorn in the microwave. And
while the popcorn is in the
microwave, or drinks for
everyone, and then you'd wait
for popcorn finish, since
there's nothing left for you to
do, but it doesn't make sense
for you to wait for the popcorn
to finish to pour your drinks,
you can just go ahead and pour
the drinks right away and then
wait for the popcorn to finish.
So asynchronous programming is
way for us to do stuff without
waiting around for things to
finish. And this is really
advantageous in JavaScript by
default allows us to do this
asynchronous programming,
however, sometimes we do want to
wait for our popcorn to finish.
For example, if instead of just
pouring drinks, maybe the next
thing instead of pouring drinks
was placed salt on popcorn. Of
course, if we want to play salt
on our popcorn, we do have to
wait for the popcorn to get out
of the microwave. So even though
placing popcorn in the microwave
has this wait time we need to be
able to tell our code I want you
to actually wait for it or No,
you're good. You can go on and
do another task. So that's kind
of the difference here. And I'll
leave some links in the GitHub
repo associated with this course
to understand this a little bit
better functions that have
functions that come with this
waiting period return something
called a problem. This, if put
popcorn in the microwave was a
function in JavaScript, it would
be a promise based function. A
promise can be either pending,
fulfilled, or rejected. And this
is how we know if our popcorn is
done. If our popcorn was a
method, putting popcorn in the
microwave, were a function in
JavaScript, when we're waiting
for the popcorn to finish, it's
in a pending state. When it's
when the popcorn is finished, it
would be fulfilled. And if we
aborted halfway through, and we
stopped waiting, it would be
rejected. So putting the popcorn
in the microwave returns a
promise. With this promise, we
have to tell our code, hey, we
want you to wait for the popcorn
to finish or you can go ahead
and you can just keep doing
stuff. So let's put this all
together with some JavaScript
syntax here. Let's say again,
we're going to be setting up
this movie night. And we need to
cook popcorn, pour drinks for
everybody. And then we need to
start a movie. So let's write
some pseudocode to pretend what
this code would look like if
this was actually a function. So
we create some function called
setup, Movie Night. And in here,
we would say okay, what's the
first thing we need to do? Okay,
we need to cook popcorn. So
let's say we have some cook
popcorn function. So we'll say,
okay, cook popcorn, then the
next thing we're gonna have to
do is we're gonna have to pour
drinks, or drink. So we'll call
some pour drinks function. Now
here's the thing, we only want
to start the movie once our
popcorn has been cooked. And
once our drinks have been
poured, so if either one of
these returned a promise, so if
either one of these returns a
promise, like cook popcorn, for
example, we would need to tell
our code here to actually wait
for the popcorn to finish
because cook popcorn is going to
be a function where we could say
let status equals cook popcorn.
And while the popcorn is being
cooked, the status is going to
be ending. Once the popcorn gets
cooked, it'll be fulfilled. If
the popcorn breaks, the
microwave explodes, the status
would be rejected. But we don't
want the status to be in a
pending situation. Before we
move on, we only want to start
our movie once these two
functions have completed. And
let's say both of these return
these promises things. So we
need to tell our code, hey, you
have to wait. Or you have to
wait for cook popcorn and for
poor drinks to finish. So what
we can do now without getting
too deep into the weeds on how
all this works, one of the
easiest things that we can do
and you'll see us use this
syntax quite often is we'll turn
this function into an async
function. When our functions are
async, we get access to a
keyword called await the await
keyword tells any promise based
function to wait for that
promise to be fulfilled or
rejected. So we say okay, we
want to await for our popcorn to
cook. And then we want to await
to pour drinks. And then we can
just go ahead and start the
movie. And we only start the
movie here once these two have
been completed. And this is why
throughout all of our code,
you'll see this await keyword
used a lot. But it can only be
used in async functions. So
basically, whenever you see this
await keyword just now Ah, okay,
the function that's being called
is promise based. And we don't
want to move on to the next step
until that function has
completed. So that's a little
bit more about promises and
asynchronous programming.
Hopefully, that's clear. If not,
like I said, there's some links
in the description to learn more
about asynchronous programming.
The reason I wanted to go
through this is because most of
the functions that we're going
to be working with are going to
be asynchronous. For example,
when we deploy a contract, what
do we have to do? Well, we have
to wait for it to be deployed.
If we don't use synchronous
programming, and we just leave
our function main like this,
what would happen is we would
write some code like contract
dot deploy, and we wouldn't wait
for it to finish. Obviously, if
we don't wait for it to finish,
and we try to run some code on a
contract that hasn't finished
deploying it, it's not going to
work. So we want to do this, we
want to have our main function
be an async function, so that we
can we can wait for our
contracts to deploy, we can wait
for things to happen, we can
wait for our popcorn to finish,
we can have the flexibility to
tell our code to either wait for
our popcorn to finish or
continue on. So now that we have
our main function as an async
function, we're going to add
some code to our main function
down here. And the code that's
added here is some syntax for
working with asynchronous
functions. And if this part is
confusing, I'm just going to say
for now, absolute, don't worry
about this. If you want to try
to understand that later. That's
fine. But for those who are
following along, we're just
going to add an add
then catch air air you can
follow along typing this
yourself or you can just copy
paste it into your code.
Basically what this allows us to
do is we have our main function,
that's an asynchronous function.
So when we call the main
function, this is some other
syntax for waiting for it to
basically finish and then
printing any errors it gets. And
that's why we do this but Again,
if this big lump of code, if
you're like what is going on
with this big clump of code,
honestly, for now, just copy
paste it. So great. We have our
asynchronous function main, we
have some code. And then we have
this lump of code, which
basically just calls our main
asynchronous function. Okay,
great. I'm gonna delete all this
for now. But you can still find
that common in the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
Awesome. Okay, so now that we
have our real basic setup, let's
go ahead and start coding. And
if this set apart is confusing,
and the async await stuff is
confusing, don't worry too much
about it. It'll make more sense
as we progress. All of our code
basically is going to be inside
of this async function main,
which is going to be our main
script for deploying our simple
storage dot soul store deploy
script is going to replicate
exactly what goes on in remix,
in remix, what was the first
thing that we always did? Well,
the first thing that we would do
is actually compile all of our
code. So we're going to want to
compile our code in our
JavaScript project as well. In
order for us to compile our
simple storage contract, we're
going to use a tool called Silk
Jas, and JavaScript actually has
a way to install projects
directly into our setups and
into our folders. If we scroll
down this silk Jas is exactly
what we're looking for. Because
it has a way to compile a
contract that imports other
contracts via relative paths,
you can see a section in this
readme and most documentation
will have something like this,
if it's JavaScript compatible.
For Node js usage, it says to
use the latest stable version of
the solidity compiler via Node
js, you can install it via NPM
npm install. So NPM is what's
known as a package manager. And
we actually installed NPM just
by installing no Jess, right, if
we do no dash dash version, you
should also be able to do NPM
dash dash version. Another tool
that it comes with is something
called core pack. And you can
type core pack dash dash
version, now we can install with
NPM using npm install silk,
however, I like the yarn package
manager a little bit better. So
we're actually going to install
the yarn package manager instead
to do all of our package
management. If you go to the
installation page, the newer way
to install yarn is just by
running core pack enable. And
the older way is to install with
NPM. If you go ahead and run
core pack enable after that
finishes, you should be able to
run yarn dash dash version.
Alternatively, you can just run
NPM i dash g core pack, and then
you can run core pack enable.
The last option you have is you
can run NPM i dash g
yarn. This will install yarn
globally for your system. But
this is considered the outdated
way to install yarn. And ideally
you run core pack enable. But in
any case, after you run those,
if you run yarn dash dash
version, you should get
something that looks like this.
Now that we have yarn, we can
actually use yarn to install all
of our projects, instead of NPM.
Back in silk Jas where it says
npm install soak, we can do the
yarn equivalents of NPM install
sock, which is going to be yarn,
add sock, this will actually go
ahead and install solc to our
project. If we open up our
folders, you'll actually see
that this added a couple of
different folders, it first
added a package dot JSON package
dot JSON is a file that tells us
a lot about our project and the
dependencies that it works with.
For example, we've installed the
soap package of 0.8 point 13.
Our yarn dot lock tells us the
exact version of all the
different packages of our
project. For example, the reason
this is so important too, is
solc has a ton of dependencies
as well. So yarn dot lock tells
us exactly what version of solc
and all the different
dependencies of solchen. Any
other project that we add. This
is autogenerated file, don't
edit the file directly. The
final bit is we got this node
modules folder. This node
modules folder is going to be
where all the installed code
that we just downloaded is, for
example, if we look at node
modules, we can see there's a
sock folder. And inside this
sock folder is all the code
associated with this soap
package that we just installed.
And since we're working with
zero point 8.7 of slowly, we
actually want to install that
specific version. So we're going
to do yarn add solc at zero
point 8.7 Dash fixed and you'll
see in our package dot JSON you
can now see zero point 8.7 Dash
fixed in our dependencies
section for sulk. Normally you
can just add your salt version
like yarn add zero point 8.7 But
there was an issue with zero
point 8.7 So we had to do zero
point 8.7 Dash fixed.
You can find the different
releases and the different
versions if you go to sulk Jas
releases and then to tags
Alright, great. Now that we have
sold, we have the ability to
actually compile our contracts,
we could either compile them in
our code and have it
automatically run whenever we
hit Deploy, or, or we could
compile them separately. If you
want to go back after this
section is an example in the
sculpt Jas repository that shows
you how to actually compile silk
right in your code. We are
actually going to compile them
separately using a soap Jas
command. The yarn command is
both used to install
dependencies and it can be used
to run scripts. If you go to
sulk Jas and you scroll down, it
says in order to use the command
line, you actually need to
install it globally. If you want
to install this globally using
yarn Global Add solc at zero
point 8.7 Dash fixed you can
absolutely go ahead. However,
since we're inside of this
folder here, which has the yarn
dot lock the package json and
the node modules yarn will be
smart enough to know i You're
looking for the soak in this
folder. So we can actually go
ahead and compile our contract
using yarn and solc Jess if you
want to see all the different
commands soak Jas allows we can
just run yarn. So Jas dash dash
help, and you'll see it'll spit
out a list of all the different
options that soft Jas has. You
can also run yarn, so Jas dash
dash version to just make sure
that we're on the correct
version, which is indeed zero
point 8.7. Now to actually
compile our simple storage at
soul, let's run the compliation
command we will run yarn, so J
S, dash dash bin since we want
the binary dash dash ABI since
we also want the ABI dash dash
include path node modules. Since
we want to include any contracts
or files in our node modules, we
aren't using any for this
project, but in the future, you
will need to include this dash
dash include path node modules
do dash dash base path of
period, this period means that
the base path is going to be
this folder dash O period, which
means we're going to output the
compiled binary and ABI to this
folder. And then finally, simple
storage dot soul. Since this is
the contract that we want to
compile, auto completed it from
simple storage to simple
storage. So by typing simple,
and then hitting Tab, but let's
go ahead and hit enter, you'll
see it's running this command to
compile this contract. And
you'll see two files get output.
One called Simple Storage soul
underscore simple storage that
API in simple storage Sol
underscore simple storage dot
bin, the ABI is obviously the
ABI of this contract, which will
need in the future. And then the
bin is going to be the binary,
or the really low level of this
code back and remix. If you
compile simple storage, that
soul, you can actually look at
compliation details, like the
ABI which we just got, or the
bytecode, which if you look at
this object 60806 That's the
same as the binary here 60806.
Alright, great. So now we've
compiled our contracts here.
Now, obviously, now if you hit
up on your keyboard, you can
actually cycle through your most
recent terminal commands. And if
you hit up enough, we can see
this command that we just ran
typing this out or hitting up a
whole bunch every single time,
it's going to be really annoying
to do anytime we want to
recompile. So what we can do is
we can add a script section in
our package dot JSON to shorten
some yarn scripts for us. So
what we'll do is back in our
package, dot JSON, a lot of
comma, and we'll add a section
called scripts, add the colon
and the brackets. And in here,
we'll say anytime we say
compile, we will run this long
command. So I'd compile we'll
put some quotes. And we'll paste
that in there. So now instead of
typing that whole thing out, as
long as we're in the same folder
that our package json is in, we
can run yarn compile. And this
will run that whole script for
us without us having to type the
whole thing out scripts are a
really useful way to make it
easier for us to run long
commands. All right, great. Now
we have our code compiled, this
is going to be equivalent to US
hitting this compile button for
us to actually go ahead and
deploy.
So now we have our simple
storage. That's all compiled,
let's learn how we can actually
deploy this thing. Remember, in
remix, we actually deployed it
to one of two different places,
we deployed it to either a
JavaScript VM, or with our
injected web three, with our
Metamask. Let's learn first ad,
do the JavaScript VM. And then
we'll learn how to use the
injected web three, or a meta
mask or some connection to an
actual test net. So in order to
deploy this to a JavaScript
virtual invite I'm in or kind of
a fake blockchain, we're gonna
need to get a fake blockchain.
Now in the future, we're going
to be using the Hardhead runtime
environment as our JavaScript
virtual machine or aka our fake
blockchain. But for this
section, I want us to use a tool
called ganache. There's a link
to this in the GitHub
repository. Ganache is similar
to a virtual machine in remix.
It's a fake blockchain that we
can run locally to actually
test, deploy and run code. It's
also a nice way to see things
that are going on in a
blockchain. Let's go ahead and
spin up the ganache application
after you install it, the
ganache application will look a
little something like this. And
to spin up a fake blockchain
really quickly, you can just go
ahead and click Quickstart. This
will spin up a fake blockchain
that's running locally on your
computer right here, which is
fantastic. It comes with a whole
bunch of fake accounts exactly
like how remix comes with a ton
of fake accounts with 100 ether
each ganache comes with a bunch
each. They also come with the
private keys that we can use in
our applications to actually
take control of these fake
accounts. Remember, don't use
these private keys on a public
blockchain. They're for
development purposes only
because a lot of people know
these private keys in our code.
One of the first things that
we're going to need to do is
actually connect to our
blockchain remix does this a
little bit behind the scenes, if
we're choosing JavaScript
virtual machine remix chooses
its own fake blockchain that it
runs. If we choose injected web
three, as we know, meta mask
pops up, and it connects to our
meta mask, this connection that
remix does, is actually doing
something really interesting.
It's not just connecting to our
meta mask by some magical
powers. It's actually connecting
to our meta mask, which has a
connection to the blockchain
behind the scenes. If you open
up your meta mask, and you go
down to you select the networks
and you select ad networks,
you'll get popped up into a UI
that looks like this. If we go
back and hit select networks
over here, we can actually see
information about these
different networks. One of the
main things that we can see is
that all these networks have
something called an RPC URL. RPC
stands for remote procedure
call. And then URL is uniform
resource locator. This RPC URL
stands for a connection to a
blockchain node that somebody is
running this this URL connects
us to make API calls and to
interact with a blockchain node.
Blockchain nodes run with
software, and some of them
expose an API call. If you look
at the NGO Aetherium website,
there actually are instructions
for you to run your own
blockchain node for a real
blockchain like Aetherium. Most
of these have flags like dash
HTTP dot ADR to expose these RPC
endpoints. So if you ever want
to run your own node, your own
real blockchain node, instead of
using meta masks or any other
the providers that we're going
to go through, you can use go
Aetherium, or whatever
blockchain you're working with
software to run your own notes.
But it's this RPC URL that
allows us to connect to Rinkeby,
if on Rinkeby ropsten, if we're
on ropsten main net if we're on
Main net, etc. And it's going to
be the way that we're going to
connect to our ganache
blockchain that we're running
inside of this application. So
if you look at the top of your
ganache here, there's a section
called the RPC server. And this
is the endpoint of our ganache
node right now. So what we can
do is we can copy this and go
back to our VS code, and paste
it in here to see if we can
connect instead of HTTP. With
these capitals, we're gonna have
a B lowercase instead of the
uppercase, because the lowercase
is more correct, and it looks
nicer. But now we have the
endpoint. Hypothetically, with
just this, we can start making
calls and API calls to this
endpoint, go to this JSON RPC
specification. Again, link will
be in the GitHub repo, we can
actually see different calls we
can make directly to our node to
get different information. eath
get blocked by hash eath get
blocked by number. And all of
these wonderful pieces in here.
Making these API calls directly
is is a little bit annoying to
do ourselves. If you want to do
it yourself, you absolutely can
using an API endpoint like Axios
or fetch. However, we're going
to use a rapper to interact with
our node and do things like
deploy and interact and other
such things with our blockchain
node. This is finally where
ethers comes
into play. Ethers js is one of
the most popular JavaScript
based tooling kits, that allows
us to interact with different
blockchains and has all these
rappers that make all these API
calls and do all these things
with Aetherium, and polygon and
avalanche and any EVM compatible
chain. The other incredibly
popular package that does the
same thing is going to be web
three.js. And you've probably
heard about this and you'll
probably see it a little bit
more throughout this course and
throughout your web three
journey. The reason that we're
using ethers is that ethers is
the main tool that powers the
hard hat environment and I
really enjoy it myself. And
remember, if you ever get lost
with any of this, you can always
come back to their documentation
to install it. As you can see
here, you can just run npm
install ethers, we're just going
to do yarn, add ethers.
And now you should see in your
package json, we now have ethers
added in here. Awesome. Now back
in our code, we're going to
import ethers into our
deployed.js script so that we
can use all the wonderful tools
that comes with so we'll say
const ethers equals require
ethers. For those of you doing
the TypeScript edition of this
course, this will be import
instead of require now that we
have ethers in here, we can
create our provider object in
our main function. The reason we
we pull ethers outside of the
main function is because we do
want to pull our package into
our script. Before we call main,
we want to make sure all of this
is done first. So you'll see
this is kind of the the normal
setup of our scripts. At the
top, we import any dependencies
or external packages, we'll have
our main function, and then
we'll call our main function at
the bottom. const is a keyword
similar to let the const keyword
makes it so that ethers can't be
changed. So we can't change
this. Our ethers variable,
anytime we use const require is
a function for us to import the
ethers package. Now remix does
all this behind the scenes. But
the way we're going to do it in
our code here is we're going to
say const provider equals new
ethers dot providers dot JSON
RPC provider. And then we're
going to pass this string as our
provider. So we're saying hey,
we're going to connect to this
URL right here. Awesome. So this
is the way that our script is
going to connect to our
blockchain, our local
blockchain. Now let's get an
actual wallet here. With a
private key and a balance and
everything, we can see all of
our wallets and private keys in
our ganache here. So the way to
get this set up is we can say
const. Wallet equals new ethers
dot wallet. And this wallet
function takes in a couple of
input parameters, like a private
key, and a provider, the private
key will go to Kenosha and just
choose one of these private
keys. And we're going to paste
this right into our code. And
then we're gonna do comma
provider and save that. Now
pasting your private key
directly into your code is a
huge nono. And we're going to
learn how to avoid this in the
future. It's okay right now,
since we're just using one of
the ganache private keys, and
you have no risk of having any
money associated with this
account. These two lines alone
give us everything that we need
to interact with smart contract,
they give us our connection to
the blockchain, and they give us
a wallet with a private key so
we can sign different
transactions. If you remember
back to our blockchain basics
section. This is the private key
that we're using to sign all of
our transactions to encrypt our
transactions. Now that we have a
provider and a wallet, let's go
ahead and grab our contract
objects from these two files
here. In order to deploy our
contract, we're gonna need the
ABI and we're going to need the
binary compiled code of the
contract. So we're going to need
to read from these two files to
read from these two files, we're
going to need to use a package
called Fs. So back at the top,
we're gonna do const Fs equals
require Fs extra I autosave, all
the time, you'll see like, I'll
do something and then my white
dot will go away a lot. It's
because my fingers have a habit
of pretty much anytime I stop
typing I save so so please
remember to save early and
often, this Fs extra should come
directly with your node project.
But if not, you can always add
it with yarn, add Fs extra, and
you should see it in our package
dot JSON. Now we can get the ABI
and the binary, we can say
const, abi equals Fs dot read
file sync, which means we're
going to synchronously read from
this file, we could do it
asynchronously. But we want to
wait for this file to get done.
So we're gonna say read file
sync. And depending on your VS
code, if you scroll over, you
might even get some information
about this function popup like
this, which can be really
helpful, we can see that we need
the path for the file we want to
read. And then any options as
well path the file that we want
to read the at the ABI located
at dot slash simple storage,
underscore soul underscore
simple storage dot AVI and then
we're going to do a comma of U
T, F eight is UTF. Eight is the
encoding that we do for this
file here. Don't worry too much
about what that means for now.
So we need the ABI. And we also
need the binary, which is in
this second file. Simple Storage
underscore soul underscore
simple storage dot bin. So we're
gonna say const binary equals Fs
dot read file sync. We're gonna
give it the path Hear, which is
going to be dot slash, simple
storage soul, simple storage dot
bin, and then the encoding
option, which again is going to
be, and it should look like
this. Now that we have the
binary, we have the ABI, we can
create something called a
contract factory, which is not
to be confused with the factory
pattern in ethers. A contract
factory is just an object that
you can use to deploy contracts.
So we're gonna say const,
contract factory equals new
ethers dot contract, factory.
And we're going to pass it, the
API binary. And the wallet, we
pass the ABI so that our code
knows how to interact with the
contract the binary, obviously,
because this is the main
compiled code in our wallet so
that we have a private key we
can use to sign deploying this
contract, then I usually like to
write a little console dot log,
saying something like deploying
these wait. And we can actually
deploy this contract with ethers
by doing const. Contract equals
await, contract factory dot
deploy. Now, this is the first
time we've seen this await
keyword and you can only use the
await keyword inside of an async
function. The reason we want
this await keyword we're telling
our code to stop here, wait for
contract to deploy. And this
await keyword means that this
will resolve the promise
contract in this contract
factory dot deploy with the
await here returns a contract
object. So now I could do
something like console dot log
contract. Let's see what happens
when we run this code node
deploy dot j s, we scroll up, we
see deploying, please wait. And
then we see this massive object
that gets printed out. This is
the contract object that we just
deployed. And in fact, if we go
over to our ganache, we can see
that the address that we're used
for our wallet has a little bit
less balance and has a
transaction count of one. If we
were working with truffle, we'd
be able to see the contracts
here we're working with hard
hat, so you won't be able to see
the contracts in here. But if
you go to transactions, we can
indeed see the transaction that
we just created. This is similar
to ether scan. But for our local
blockchain, we can see the
sender address, the creation
address, the value, gas price,
all this stuff associated with
this contract. You can also see
the different blocks. Since
we've only made one transaction
only one block has been mined.
And this is awesome. We have all
this other stuff associated with
it. Great job. You just deployed
a contract to your own local
blockchain with ethers. Jas.
This is fantastic, Awesome work.
Now let me show you what happens
if we don't use the await
keyword here. We're not telling
our code to stop. We're saying
hey, deploy this contract and
then just keep going. So we
never actually checked to see if
this deploy function finished.
So let's see what happens when
we run this instead. Instead of
that big contract object, we get
this promise in its pending
state because our code actually
finished before our contract
could finish deploying. So we
see promise pending here
instead, this is why the await
keyword is so important. We're
saying hey, wait for this to
finish the await keyword also
resolves a promise. So it'll
wait for the promise to exit
it's pending state. And then
it'll return whatever the
pending promise returns. So
contract factory to deploy
returns a promise that returns a
contract. In fact, if we go to
the ethers documentation, we
look up deploy. And here we can
see contract factory methods
contract factory dot deploy. If
we look at the definition of the
function, it says contract
factory dot deploy takes a whole
bunch of arguments and some
overrides this arrow is saying
this is what it returns, it
returns a promise that resolves
to a contract. And that's why we
need this await keyword because
contract factory to deploy by
itself just returns a promise.
But if we do await contract
factory dot deploy, we're saying
it returns a promise that
resolves to a contract. And
we're waiting for it to finish
deploying to resolve to a
contract object. So that's gonna
be a major difference here.
Awesome work. So that's gonna be
why this await keyword is so
important. And again, you can
only do that in asynchronous
functions. So you need this
async keyword at the top of your
function names. Awesome work. So
we've deployed a contract to our
ganache. Shane, this is
fantastic. Let's play with this
a little bit more. So what else
can we do? Remember how in remix
and in Metamask, we could add a
whole bunch of stuff. We could
add a gas limit, we could add
some value when we were doing
our trends. that we could press
the transact button. We know
that when we're working with
Metamask, and we want to send
some money between our accounts,
we can actually choose our gas
price, our priority fee, all
this other stuff, we can
actually do all that in ethers
as well. So if we wanted to
await contract factory to
deploy, but with a certain gas
price, we can add these
overrides in this deploy
function here. Another really
neat trick that your Visual
Studio code might have is if you
click Command or Control,
depending on your setup, you can
actually click into a function
and see where it's defined and
see everything about this
function. So if I command
clicked, I could see that I'm
now in Node modules ethers
project contract source of Ts,
all this stuff. And I can see
exactly the function definition
of this deploy function on the
contract factory object, which
shows us the same code as what
we saw in the documentation. We
see we have a deploy function,
it takes some arguments, and
then it returns this little
semicolon means it returns a
promise that resolves to a
contract, which is really nice.
These are in here are actually a
list of overrides that we can
specify with some brackets. So
what we can do is we can put
some brackets in our deploy
function here and specify
certain things like for example,
we can specify the gas price to
being some number. And now if we
were to run this, we would
deploy this contract with a gas
price of this, we could add a
gas limit, we can add a whole
bunch of different overrides in
our deploy function here. Well,
what else can we do? Well, we
can wait for a certain number of
blocks for our contract finish
with so we've deployed the
contract. But maybe we want to
wait one block to make sure it
actually gets attached to the
chain. So we can say const.
Deployment received equals
await, contract dot deploy
transaction dot Wait, and
specify the number of
confirmations that we want to
actually wait. So we'll wait one
block confirmation to make sure
that this happened. And then we
can do console dot log, this
deployment receipt option. So if
we run the code now, we can see
all this information about our
transaction, and we can see
exactly what our transaction
looks like, we can see there's
two is no because we're creating
a contract from is going to be
this ganache address that we got
the private key for, we see the
contract address that we created
transaction index, we can see
gas use gas use log bloom block
hash transaction, and we can see
all this information about our
transaction, something I want
you to take note of is the
deployment receipt and the
deployment transaction, I want
you to separate these two
because it's going to make your
life a lot easier. So we're
going to do quick console dot
log, here is the deployment
transaction. And then we'll do
console dot log contract, dot
deploy transaction. And then I'm
going to copy this whole line by
just typing Command C or Ctrl. C
right there. And then here is
the deployment. Here is the
transaction receipt. And then
this deployment is receipt is
the transaction receipt. So I'm
just going to rename this to
transaction receipt. To make it
a little bit clearer, which ones
which, and we'll run this one
more time. You only get a
transaction receipt, when you
wait for a block confirmation.
Otherwise, you're gonna get the
contract object, which has the
deploy transaction with it, this
distinction will be more
important later on. But I wanted
you to know what the difference
between the two transaction
receipt is what you get when you
wait for a block confirmation,
the deployment transaction or
the transaction response,
transaction response is what you
get just when you create your
transaction. So transaction
receipts transactional response,
they're different receipt is
what you get when you wait for a
transaction to finish. And then
response is just what you
initially get. Make sense? Okay,
great. We're gonna go ahead and
delete those. But those lines
will be in the code associated
with the GitHub. Now you saw
when we actually printed out
those receipts, we got all this
stuff in here, because deploying
a contract is actually just
sending a transaction, as we've
said before, so if we want to
see what's really going on under
the hood, we can actually create
a transaction ourselves and
create a contract ourselves just
by specifying the transaction
information. So how will we do
that? Let's deploy this contract
again, but only purely using
transaction data. So we'll do a
console dot log.
Let's deploy with only
transaction data. And this is
going to be the way you can
actually deploy or send
transactions purely with
transaction data you can send
any transaction this gives you
unlimited flux. ability with the
transactions you want to send,
what we can do is we can say
const, or let TX which is going
to stand for our transaction
equals, and we can just add all
of our transaction information
in here. So the first thing that
we're going to need is our nuts,
or the number that we only use
once we go back to our
transaction count, we're on four
transactions here. So we'll use
the nonce five, because that's
going to be a nonce that we
haven't used before. Every time
you send a transaction, it comes
with one of those nonces. Right,
so the nonce is a bit of a over
overused term, we saw it back in
our blockchain basics that we
use the nonce to solve that hard
problem. nonces are also used in
wallets and in signers, to send
transactions and they use a
different nones for every
transaction. So nonce, when
we're talking about wallets
talks about a number associated
with a unique transaction.
nonce, when we're talking about
blockchain mining is a value
used to solve that hard problem,
they both mean the same thing.
They both mean a number only
used once. But they're different
in these different contexts. So
we're going to use this number
only use once this unique number
for a transaction to send this,
so we're going to say nonce is
going to be five, we're going to
pick a gas price of, of this
right here, we're just going to
use the gas price of ganache
like that, we're going to pick a
gas limit of some big number,
we'll use 1123456, we'll just
use that we're gonna say two is
going to be no, right, exactly
like what we saw in our receipts
and responses down here. Since
we're creating a contract value
is going to be zero. Since we're
creating a contract, we don't
want to send an ether polygon or
avalanche. And then data is
going to be that massive binary
object in our binary bit. So in
the binary section, we're gonna
copy this massive binary piece,
and we're going to put some
quotes in here, we're gonna do
0x, and paste that in here. So
this massive, massive data piece
is the binary that we're
sending. Whenever you send a
transaction, you have this this
data object that you can fill
this stuff, we're filling our
data object with the binary with
the code that tells the theory
that tells our blockchain to
deploy our smart contract that's
going to look exactly like this.
And then finally, we want to add
the chain ID.
As we've seen before with
Metamask, if we go back over to
our networks, each one of these
EVM chains has a different chain
ID Etherium. Main net is one
ropsten is three Rinke, B is
four COVID is 42, etc. And other
EVM chains like avalanche like
polygon, are going to have their
unique chain IDs as well, or
ganache, we can see the network
ID appear is 1337 in some
people, so we can just paste
that in here. Some people have
run into some issues where the
chain ID and the network ID are
different. And the chain ID is
actually 31337. So if you have a
problem with this, try 31337
instead, but it should be 1337.
Now this is a transaction with
all this information propagated,
which is awesome. However, this
transaction isn't signed. So
nobody's sending this
transaction right now this is
just the transaction details of
what somebody wants to do, we
actually need to sign this
transaction, and then send it to
our blockchain. Cons sign, TX
response equals await, wallet
dot sign transaction, and we can
pass that TX object. And then
we'll do a console dot log of
the sign TX response in
JavaScript. Same as solidity. If
you type two backslashes, before
some code, it won't run that
code. So I'm gonna go ahead and
comment out the three lines
above. And the way that I'm
doing it is by highlighting the
sections and hitting Command
backslash, or you might hit Ctrl
backslash, but this is a
keyboard shortcut you can use to
quickly comment out entire
sections. And the reason I'm
doing this is because I want to
show you what happens when we
just run scientex response
wallet that signed transaction
back in nosh, we see that we
have four blocks in here. Let me
ask if we do this sign
transaction and we get the
signed transaction response,
will we propagate another block?
Well, let's find out run no
deploy.js, we get this massive
thing here. But if we go back to
ganache refresh, we actually
don't see another transaction
sent. That's because we're only
signing a transaction here,
we're not actually sending it.
So the signed transaction
response. This big number here
represents a signed transaction
but not a cent transaction,
which is different. You can
actually send one of these
transactions by changing this
line a little bit. So instead of
scientex response, we'll change
this to send TX response equals
await wallet dot send
transaction TX then once We send
the transaction here, we can do
a wait, send transaction
response, that Wait, one, we're
gonna wait one block
confirmation to make sure this
transaction actually goes
through. And we can run node.js.
And it looks like it's done. But
if we actually scroll up, we
actually got an error here. So
there's this huge, massive thing
here. And if we scroll up, we'll
eventually see TX reject error,
the TX doesn't have the correct
nuts, which just for some
practice, let's go ahead, type
this into Google and see what we
get. We actually get a web three
Jas from four years ago, trying
to call leaf picked, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. It looks like this is a
meta mask issue that they ran
into. And they said, you have to
reset your account in meta mask,
which we could do. But let's
make this a little bit more
specific. Let's say ethers. JS
looks like we don't get it looks
like as of right now, from this
recording, we don't get a Stack
Exchange eath or a Stack
Overflow question for this
trolley, because this is pretty
straightforward. We don't have
the correct nonce for our
transaction. But this would be a
good time to actually make this
a question on Stack Overflow or
Stack Exchange Aetherium so that
it shows up first. So we
actually don't get the correct
nuts, we're going to want to
make this a nonce of four you
can see here account has a nonce
of four TX has a nonce of five.
So we actually would want this
to be four. Now an easier way to
always get the correct nonce
here is going to be actually
just calling the transaction
count from the wallet. So back
in the ethers documentation,
there's actually some good
samples here on how to assigning
a message and then how to
actually send these messages. So
we can do a weight wallet dot
get transaction count to get the
nuts. So back in our code, we
could do const nuns equals
await, oops, copy pasted, await
wallet dot get transaction
count. And then we can just
place the nonce right here.
Now, let's try running this
again. And it looks like this
one did indeed go through. We
can verify on ganache here. We
do indeed see we're currently on
block five now and we have one
extra transaction. Now we could
go ahead and just run this
again. And we'll never have to
worry about actually updating
this nonce ourselves. Since
we're just calling wallet dot
get transaction count to keep
updating it current block is six
and the our additional
transaction has indeed gone
through awesome. I showed you
how to actually sign the
transaction. But we didn't sign
the transaction for our central
injection. Well, why not? If you
command click or control click,
or you go to the documentation
for ethers, we can see the code
for send transaction. So first,
it does some check provider
stuff. There's some stuff to
populate the transaction. But we
can actually see that before it
sends the transaction even in
ethers, it signs the transaction
first, and then calls this dot
provider dot send transaction.
So if you just call send
transaction with the transaction
details like we did here, it's
the same as signing it first and
then sending it with the
provider. Okay, great. So we've
learned how to send a
transaction using pure
JavaScript and using pure
ethers. One of the main
takeaways from this is that
every time we change the
blockchain, every time we change
state, every time we use gas,
we're sending a transaction that
looks pretty much exactly like
this, the data is going to be
the differentiator, the data for
us here was data saying to
create a new contract, when we
make transactions, like adding
people or storing the data that
we're going to be passing in our
transaction is going to be data
associated with calling these
functions. And when we actually
call functions in ethers, or in
Hardhead. We're not going to do
this kind of raw const, TX, and
list out all the stuff like here
and list out the raw data,
right? Because that's really,
really hard ethers and hard hat
are going to make this process a
lot easier. So for now, let's go
ahead, comment out this whole
section, which again, if we copy
this whole thing, and then hit
Command, slash, or control
slash, or whatever the shortcut
is on your environment, that'll
actually comment this out. Let's
go ahead and uncomment this
section so that we deploy our
contract using kind of the ether
is much easier to read way than
this weird TX stuff. Oh, cool.
So we've changed our script back
to deploy our contracts like
this. Now that we've actually
deployed our contract, we can
learn how to interact with our
contract through code as well,
the same way that we click these
buttons in remix, we're going to
code it out for ourselves here.
So if we look at symbol storage,
we have a button for add person
for store. And then we have
these view functions as well.
The easiest one is going to be
the Retrieve function, which
grabs our favorite number,
retrieve returns favorite
number. So we can call that in
ethers by doing const. current
favorite number equals await.
contract.we retrieve. The
contract object that we have is
what's returned from our
contract factory as long as
we've awaited it the contract
object is going to come with all
the functionality described in
our API. That's why we had to
pass the API to our contract
factory. If we look inside our
API piece here, we can see it
has a ton of information on the
different functions that we can
call and the types that it has
and the return types and
everything like that. For
example, if I look up retrieve,
I can see down here, we have
retrieve, we can see that the
name of this function is going
to be retrieved. And the outputs
are going to be a un 256, of
type Nuun 256. Now, this is a
little bit difficult to read
because it's not formatted.
Since we call this dot API, it's
going to be a little bit hard to
read. But we could change it the
dot JSON. And then you'll see
it's highlighted a little bit, I
can even do format document with
prettier. And you'll see it
actually formats to be a lot
easier to read now and go back
to retrieve. And we can see,
this block of code here defines
what the Retrieve function can
and can't do. I'm going to
change it back to abi. And it
looks like my formatting has
stayed, which is great. This is
much easier to read than it was
before. As I said, the ABI or
the application binary interface
is incredibly important for
working with our contracts. If
we give our code just this huge
bytecode thing, it's gonna be
really hard for any processor to
decompile this or understand
what exactly what the functions
are that are going on here.
There are decompiler options out
there, like ether VM, that IO
slash decompile. That can
decompile some bytecode into the
solidity. But it can be really
tricky to get it exactly right.
So it's much easier just to have
the ABI to say, hey, this lump
of code, this lump of numbers
and garbled nonsense is this.
When we deploy this bytecode to
the blockchain, and we call
functions on it, the code will
automatically allow those
functions to get called if they
do exist. But in order for our
code to know that they exist,
it's much easier just to give it
the API. So we can get our
current favorite number like
this. Let's go ahead and console
dot log, the current favorite
number. Now that we've edited
this code, we're going to let me
zoom out a little bit. Now that
we've edited this code, we're
going to connect organ nosh
instance, we're going to connect
a wallet with a private key that
we got from the top of our
ganache here, we're gonna grab
the ABI and the binary of our
contracts, and connect them to a
new contract factory object,
which is connected to that
wallet. So that wallet will be
the one to actually deploy the
contract, we'll deploy the
contract with const contract
equals await contract factory
dot deploy, we will wait one
block for that transaction to
finish. And in fact, we're not
going to use transaction
receipt. So for now, we're just
going to delete that part. We're
not going to do any of this
here. So I'm going to delete it
for now. However, I'll leave
this section commented out in
the GitHub repo. And then we're
going to call contract retrieve
which should return our current
favorite number. Since this is a
view function, this contract
call won't cost us any gas. If
we look at simple storage, that
soul we can see retrieve is a
view function. And remember view
and pure functions, if called
outside of a contract function
call don't cost any gas, we're
just reading up the blockchain,
we're not changing any variables
on chain, we're not changing the
state of the blockchain. So this
won't cost any gas. So let's go
ahead and run this. Perfect, we
get deploying, please wait. And
then we get this big number
response. So what's this big
number response here? Big number
is a library that comes with the
ethers application that helps us
work with numbers. If you
actually scroll down, they even
have a section saying why can I
just use numbers, you'd expect
current favorite number to just
be zero, but it returns this
weird hex thing that says his
big number true this weird, big
number thing. So solidity can't
use decimal places, and
JavaScript has a hard time with
decimal places. And this is kind
of the more specific rationale
for why not to use numbers, what
you'll see a lot of the time
instead of numbers is you'll see
strings like zero, you'll see
JavaScript use strings like
this, or big numbers. Now, if I
were to try to pass a number
like this in JavaScript, this
number would be too big for
JavaScript to understand. So we
want to use big numbers or
strings when working with
ethers. Now we can make this
more readable by adding.to
string at the end and printing
out the string version of this
big number. Now, if I rerun this
code, we can see we get zero,
which makes sense again, because
our favorite number gets
initialized to the zero value,
if not specified, and we haven't
called store yet. So awesome. So
that is, that's working
perfectly. So this is what our
current favorite number is.
Let's make this console dot log
a little bit more syntactical.
We're going to use something
called string interpolation. So
we can interpolate our string
here with variables. Typically
in JavaScript when working with
strings, use double quotes.
However, if you want to mix
variables with actual strings,
you can use backticks instead.
So we're going to use some that
backticks here, and we're gonna
say current favorite number to
call in here. And to tell
JavaScript that this is a
variable that we want to read,
we put a little dollar sign and
a bracket around it, like this.
Now, if we run this code again,
it's saying deploying, please
wait, and we get current
favorite number is zero, because
JavaScript goes, Okay, this is a
string, ah, dollar sign, curly
brace looks like this is going
to be some variable or some
JavaScript that you want me to
interpret and close it off, and
then backtick. Cool. So our
current favorite number is going
to be zero. Great. So let's
update on the contract the
number by calling the store
function. So we'll say const,
transaction response equals
await, contract dot store, and
we'll add seven. Now since seven
is a small number, you can just
pass it like seven. But passing
it like seven in a string also
works. Again, this is because if
we want to pass some crazy
massive number, JavaScript would
get confused. So it's usually
best practice to pass variables
to contract functions as
strings, even though that might
be a little bit confusing ethers
is smart enough to know that
this seventh string is actually
seven the number then we can do
const. Transaction received
equals await transaction
response that Wait, one. So
we'll wait one block here. This
is similar to us doing contract
dot deploy transaction dot Wait,
the syntax here is a little bit
different than what we saw up
here. Because this is using a
contract factory. And this is
calling a function on a
contract. So when we call the
function on the contract, we get
a transaction response. When we
wait for the transaction
response to finish, we get the
transaction receipt. Now I can
do const, updated, favorite
number two equals await on track
dot retrieve. And then console
dot log updated. favorite number
is, and we'll do a little string
interpolation, updated, favorite
number like that? Now let's go
ahead and run this. So in this
process, what are we doing,
we're deploying the contract,
we're getting the initial value,
we're going to update our
contract by calling store which
is going to cost gas. So this is
a transaction, we're going to
get the transaction response,
then we're gonna get the
transaction receipt, we're not
going to do anything with the
transaction receipt, I want to
ingrain in you all that these
two are different transaction
response and transaction
receipt, and you'll see why in
the future. And then we'll get
the updated favorite number, and
then we're just going to print
it out. So let's do this. Boom,
and perfect. Deploying, please
wait, current favorite number is
zero, updated favorite number is
seven. And if we go to our
ganache instance, we go to
transactions, we can see, we now
have a contract call at the top,
we have the sender, the contract
address, the gas price, all this
stuff, and we see our
transaction data right here. So
this transaction data is what
gets sent in that data slot of
our transaction object. Ethers
is just doing that on the back
end for us so that we don't have
to make that big transaction
object there. All right,
awesome. You've successfully
deployed a contract to your own
local ganache instance, or your
own JavaScript virtual machine.
This is great.
Now let's clean this up a little
bit. Because if we look up here,
we have both our connection to
the blockchain and our private
key stored directly in our code,
we were to push this code up to
a GitHub or some other code
repository, if you will, will be
able to see our code. If we look
into ploy dot j s of my code,
ah, there's something else in
here, we don't actually see the
private key or the RPC URL in
here. So what's going on?
Remember, if you give out your
private key, whoever has your
private key owns your funds. So
even though this is a fake,
private key that doesn't have
any real money in it, we still
don't want to have to hard code
our private keys into our code,
just in case we accidentally
share code with somebody. So
what can we do? Well, one of the
most popular methods is actually
creating something called a dot
EMV file or an environment
variable. And if you're familiar
with environment variables, you
can actually set them right in
your terminal, but we're gonna
set them in our dot env. So what
you want to do is you're gonna
want to create a dot env file.
And this is going to be a file
where you store its sensitive
information. And this is going
to be a file, we're never going
to share this with anybody. This
dot env file will stick
variables of our choosing into
the environment of our code. So
for example, if I pull up my
terminal here, and I do echo
cat, this is going to reflect
what the cat environment
variable is for us. Right now
there is no cat environment
variable. However, if I do
export, cat equals dog, and now
I do echo dollar sign cat, I get
dog output. This is what an
environment variable is, it's a
variable in our terminal or in
our scripting environment, since
I don't want to have to type
export, private key equals blah,
blah, blah, every time, what
we're going to do instead is
we're going to stick them into
this dot env file. So when this
dot env, we can put private key
equals. And we can grab this
private key from our script, and
paste it in like this. And a
note, some tools look for the
0x, at the beginning of the
private key ethers, and hard hat
is smart enough that either one
works, but if you run into some
issues, just know that sometimes
you might have to put your 0x at
the front of this. Great. So now
we have a private key in an
environment variable. What do we
do now? Well, in our deploy.js,
we want to grab this environment
variable and stick it into our
script here, so that our script
can then stick it into our
environment. So we're going to
add a tool called dot env. To
make this easier, so we're gonna
do yarn, add dot env. And if we
look at the dot env package, can
read more about it and read
about how to add it with NPM.
Again, we're just using yarn
add. But then we can just call
this require dot E and V dot
config. And this will pull in
all our environment variables.
So we can just do require
dot EMV config, we should see
this on our package that JSON,
we do. Excellent. Now that we
pulled it in, we actually get
access to our private key
environment variable, you can
access environment variables in
JavaScript, are using process
dot EMV. So instead of putting
our private key here, we're
gonna delete that whole thing
and substitute it with process
dot EMV, that private key, and
we'll save and it'll reformat
for us to make sure this is
actually working, we can just
hit up after we save up, up up
up up a bunch and go back to no
deploy to Jas. And we see we get
the exact same setup. And if we
scroll back, you can see a
transaction has indeed gone
through. If you want to double
check that this is actually
printing out your private key,
we could do console dot log,
press study and via private key
we run, we see that that is
indeed the private key coming
from our environment variable
here. Awesome. Now our RPC URL
here is isn't really something
that we need to secure however,
maybe we're going to use a
certain API key or maybe a
certain endpoint that only we
want to have access to. And we
don't want anybody else to be
using our RPC endpoint. So we're
going to add this to our dot env
file as well. So in our dot env.
When I copy this here, I'm gonna
say RPC URL equals, and I paste
that in there, just like that.
And we're gonna delete here. And
we're gonna do the exact same
thing, say process dot e NV dot
RPC URL. And now we're going to
run this again. And I'm going to
take out that console dot log.
And we should get the exact same
response because all we did was
swap out our RPC URL with our
environment variable, which is
going to be exactly what it was
before. So we go ahead and run
this, and we get the exact same
response. And if we go to
ganache, we see that we do
indeed get a transaction here,
which is perfect. Awesome. So
we've learned how to add
environment variables to our dot
env file. So that so that just
in case, we want to share our
code, or we push our code up to
GitHub, which we'll do in later
sections, we don't accidentally
expose our private keys or our
RPC URLs. Now all the code that
we have in our project here, if
we push it up to GitHub, or
share it with somebody else, all
this code will get pushed up,
including our dot env file.
However, if you look at my code
samples here for this course, we
don't see a dot env file in
here. So how is that possible?
Well, what we want to do
whenever we have a project is
create a dot Git ignore file.
And in here, we want to put in
v. And we also want to put in
Node modules. This means that
when working with Git and
working with version control,
which we're going to do a little
bit later, we won't push our dot
env file up to GitHub. And we
also won't push up known
modules. So if we go back to my
example here, we don't see, we
don't see a dot env file, but we
do see a dot env dot example,
just to show you what one would
look like. So it doesn't really
matter that I have them in here.
Now, if you're really paranoid,
there's something else you can
actually do when running your
scripts and running your
commands. Let's say you didn't
want to put your private key
into a dot env file because you
were nervous that you would
accidentally push it up or
something. What you can do is
you can add your private key in
your RPC URL as environment
variables right in the command
line. So before you run Node
deploy, that's as well you can
do, you can say RPC URL equals,
paste your RPC around. And then
you can say private key. equals
and then paste your private key
and then do node deploy.js.
Setting these right before we
run our script is the exact same
as if we had set them into dot
env. Here If we hit run, we see
the exact same output, which
means that our RPC URL and our
private key went through
successfully. This way for key
management is fine. But our
rights doing this, it's going to
be much better. But it still
makes me a little bit nervous in
our development environments
with our fake private keys,
having our code in the dot env
file like this is, is okay,
right? Because we don't really
care if this key gets hacked,
like nobody's using it. But when
we move to a more professional
setup, this can be a little bit
scary. So how can we make this
even more secure? Well, what we
can do is actually we can
encrypt our private key and
store our encrypted key locally.
That way, if for some reason
somebody does get into our
account, our private key isn't
just sitting around in plain
text, it's encrypted. And you'll
need to know a password that
only you know to get into it. So
how do we add that? Well, first,
we're going to create a new file
called encrypt key.js. And this
is some code that we're going to
use to actually encrypt a key.
And we'll store that locally
instead of our private key in
plain text. This will make us
even more secure so that we
don't have our private key just
hanging around in plain text
here. So let's go ahead and
build the script to encrypt our
private key. So we're going to
use the exact same setup as we
did for our deploy script. We're
going to do an async function
main.
And then down here, I'm just
gonna go ahead and copy from
deployed J S. We're gonna use
this exact same setup, and paste
it. Okay, great. We're gonna be
using ethers J, s, and r dot E
and V again. So we're going to
add these in const ethers equals
require ethers const, FS equals
require Fs extra. And then
require dot env. Config.
Alright, so right now, in our
dot env, we do have this private
key. And again, if you don't
want to have the private key in
their way you can just do is you
can do private key equals and
then you know, node, whatever
script you want to run. So we're
going to set this script up to
run our encrypt key one time.
And then we can remove our
private key from anywhere in our
workspace so that it's no longer
in plain text anywhere. So what
we want to do is we want to say
const wallet, and we're gonna
create a new wallet, but a
little bit differently. We're
gonna say equals new ethers dot
wallet, process dot E and V dot
private key. So we do need our
private key to stick in here.
But then once we create this
wallet, we're gonna say const.
Encrypted JSON key equals await
ethers dot encrypt, this encrypt
function is going to return an
encrypted JSON key that we can
store locally and that we can
only decrypt it with the
password. And it takes two
parameters. It takes a private
key password and a private key.
So in our dot EMV, just for
right, now we're going to create
a private key password. And I'm
going to say it's password. But
obviously, this is a terrible
password. And you should never
use password as your password.
But for now, we're just going to
leave it as password since I'm
encrypting this big key anyways.
So we're going to encrypt it by
passing the password process
study and v dot private key
password. And we're also going
to pass the private key, it's
going to be ethers, it's going
to be wallet dot encrypt. We're
also going to pass it process
dot EMV dot private key. Now
let's go ahead and run this
right now. And then we'll
console dot log out this
encrypted JSON key and see what
happens when we run this. So to
run this, we're going to do
node, encrypt key.js. And hit
enter. And we'll see what
happens when we console log it
out this JSON object here is
what our key looks like,
encrypted. So it's got the
address this ID version, all
this other stuff. And all this
other stuff is the encrypted
version of this key. If somebody
gets into our account and they
see this, they'll have to know
the password to decrypt this
private key, they'll need to
know the password to decrypt
this JSON object back into a
private key. So what we're going
to do, now that we've encrypted
it, we're going to save it. So
we'll do Fs dot write, file
sync, we're going to pass it to
dot slash dot encrypted key dot
JSON, comma encrypted JSON key.
So we're saving it to a new file
called dot encrypted key dot
JSON. And we're passing it this
encrypted key that we just made.
So if we open up our file
explorer, and we run this
command,
you'll see we get a new file
called dot encrypted key dot
JSON. And it's this encrypted
key here, which is awesome. So
now what we want to do in our
dot Git ignore is add dot
encrypted key dot JSON, so that
we don't accidentally push this
up to GitHub. And now we have an
encrypted key and we can go to
our private key and delete this
from our dot env file. We can
also delete our private key
password from our WMV file so
that the password isn't just
hanging around in plain text.
Now that We have an encrypted
key. Back in our deploy script,
we can change the way that we
actually get a wallet. So at the
top, we're getting our wallet
just by passing in the private
key like this, we're not going
to do that, we're going to use
our encrypted key that we just
created. So we're going to do is
we're going to say const
encrypted JSON equals Fs dot
read file sync. That slash dot
encrypted key dot JSON, comma
UTF eight, this Fs dot read file
sync is just going to read from
our encrypted key dot JSON into
this encrypted JSON variable
here. Next, we're going to
create a wallet from this
encrypted key. We're gonna say
let wallet equals new ethers dot
wallet, dot from encrypted JSON
sync. And all these commands
that we're working with ethers,
we can of course, find them in
the documentation from encrypted
JSON sync takes the encrypted
JSON and a password and returns
a Wallet Object. So we're going
to pass it that encrypted JSON
that we just read. And then
we're going to pass it password
which we're going to do process
dot EMP dot private key
password. And then finally, the
reason I use let here is because
now we have to connect this
wallet back to our provider. If
you look here, we're not
connecting our wallet with a
provider. When we make our
transactions with our contract
factory, we need to make sure
the wallet knows about the
provider here. So we can just
say wallet equals await wallet
dot connect provider. Now, if we
run our deploy dot j s with our
private key password as an
environment variable, it should
still deploy. So we can do
private key password equals
password, which yes, we know is
terrible. But that's what we're
using for now node deploy dot j
s, we should get the same output
we've been seeing this whole
time and we do we're able to no
longer have our private key in
our dot env file not in
plaintext anymore, it's in this
encrypted key. So that just in
case somebody hacks our
computer, they still won't be
able to send in new transactions
unless they know the password.
This is awesome. One more thing
to know, if you type history, if
somebody got into your computer,
a hacker could actually see
private key password equals
password in your bash history.
If you run history, dash c, you
actually will clear your
history. Now if I type history,
I can just see that the most
recent command I wrote was
history, this is really just
some of the bare minimum for
encryption and keeping your key
safe. And it might seem
ridiculous that somebody might
be able to hack your computer
and read your encrypted private
keys and everything. But as your
projects get bigger and bigger,
it is really important to know
about private key security and
private key safety and, and for
this course really just giving
you the bare minimum here and
showing you how to encrypt keys
and how to be a little bit safer
here. Now for the rest of this
course, we are going to be just
using this syntax with our
private key in a dot env file.
The reason why we're doing like
this for the rest of the course
is it is a little bit easier,
I'm really hoping Hardhead add
some additional features to make
private key encryption much
safer and also easier to use in
the future. And they probably
will. And the other reason that
we're okay to do this here is
because you've solemnly sworn
that you're not going to use an
account that has any real money
in it for the duration of this
course, you're only going to use
private keys that have tests on
Aetherium or are fake private
keys like this one that we got
from ganache. In fact just to
really hone this in in the smart
contract kit slash full blocked
in solidity course, Jas GitHub
repo in the discussions tab, you
go to announcements, I've
created one called the dot end
pledge. Because recently I've
seen too many people follow a
tutorial that doesn't tell them
about the security risks of
doing this. And I've made this
dot EMV pledge, I would love
everyone to jump on and read.
And if you agree, at the bottom,
leave a comment saying I will be
safe, I will be safe, make sure
you read and you understand
what's going on in here. And I'm
not doing this to scare you.
Because again, at the end of the
day, if you use a Metamask that
only has tests that funds for
the duration of this course, you
will never have to be worried
because of your key gets
compromised. It's just test it.
So who cares? This is if you're
using a meta mask or you're
working with a meta mask that
has real funds. So I'm going to
read up the pledge because it is
really important. You understand
this when you're working with
real funds. And if you're like,
Hey, I'm not working with real
funds, I don't care, great move
past this, whatever. But when
you do work with real funds,
when you do decide, hey, I
actually want to deploy this to
a real network. Now I need real
money to do that. Come back to
this pledge. Scroll the bottom
say I will be safe and make sure
you read and you understand
this. Okay, so the pledge is, I
solemnly swear that I will never
place a private key or secret
phrase or pneumonic in a dot env
file that is associated with any
real funds. Basically, you
basically never have your
private key or your pneumonic
phrase, in plain text, anywhere.
You'll all only place private
keys in a web file that only
have tested e FF link or other
cryptocurrencies. Because again,
if your private key has only
test net funds, then that's
great. I don't care, we are
aware that if we forget a dot
Git ignore, and we push our key
phrase to GitHub, even for a
split second, or even show our
key slash phrase on the
internet, wherever it may be for
a split second, it should be
considered compromised. And you
should remove all funds
immediately. So even if you
deploy your private key to a
website, and then immediately
delete your website and think,
Oh, nobody probably got to it,
you should consider that private
key compromised, and you should
remove all your funds. And
again, this is just for real
funds. If your private key was
only tested, funds gets
compromised. Well, who cares? I
do that all the time, you've
been seeing me do that all the
time, because it only has tested
funds in it. If at the end of
this course, you want to steal
all of my tests that funds I
mean, have a blast, it would be
annoying to me at worst. If I'm
unsure if my account has real
funds in it, I will assume it
has real funds in it. So if you
don't know if it has real funds,
assume it has real funds, and
you will not use it for
developing purposes. And then
finally, I am aware that even if
I hit Add Account on my meta
mask or other eath wallet, I
will get a new private key, but
it will share the same secret
phrase slash pneumonic of all
the other accounts generated in
the meta mask or other eath
Wallet. So if I'm in my meta
mask here, and I hit Create
account, I will get a new
private key with the new
account. However, all of these
accounts that I've created with
this Create Account button have
the exact same pneumonic phrase
or secret phrase. If I import an
account with a private key, it's
going to have a different
pneumonic phrase. But all of the
ones that I generate inside the
wallet are all going to have the
same phrase. Okay, great.
Hopefully that'll make sense. I
have some pledge additions here.
For this course, I will only use
funds associated with a brand
new never before use meta mask
or other eath wallet. Again,
this is not to scare you, if you
just work with a brand new meta
mask, you don't have to worry
about any of this and just refer
back to this when you start
looking at real money and real
private keys. I'm aware that my
account associated with my
private key is the same on test
nets that it is on Main nets. So
like I was showing you, my
private key on Rinkeby is going
to be the same as my private key
I'm on a main net, if I must use
a private key associated with
real funds in the future, until
I am 100% sure what I am doing,
I will always either use one of
the encrypted methods that
Patrick showed you some better
encryption stuff that I didn't
show or use the command line way
to pass private keys and then
delete the command line history
right after. If I'm never
actually deploying anything to
make that myself or work with a
private key with real funds. I
do not need to be concerned.
Take a look at this. Read this
internalize it, it should make
you confident. Now again, I'm
not saying this to scare you.
I'm saying this to instill
confidence in you that these are
some of the things that we want
to think about. Okay, great. In
here, I will be safe.
Boom, I will be safe. And if you
want to copy paste this on
Twitter, put this in a huge
tweet thread. Go for it. The
more people who know about this,
the more people who understand
the security risks of their WMV
files and their private keys,
the better. So thank you for
listening to this. I know I
definitely belabor the point,
but it is really important.
Let's continue with the course.
Alright, so we're just about
done here. However, there's one
or two more things we want to do
just to clean this all up right
now when we're auto saving
reason, the VS code plugin for
us to auto format. However, in
the future, if anybody else
comes across our repository,
they might not have the Vyas
code auto format or on. So we
want to give users a way to
format their code. So it matches
the styles that we use. So we
have prettier the extension
installed. We can also add
prettier as a Node js module
that can tell other users who
don't have a Vyas code exactly
how to format both their
JavaScript and the solidity.
There is a prettier plugin
solidity located here, there
will be a link to it in our
GitHub repo. And if we scroll
down, we can see how to install
with npm install dash dash save
Dev, which again, we're just
going to use yarn, so we're
going to do yarn, add prettier,
and then prettier plugin
solidity. So we're installing
both prettier, and the solidity
plugin for prettier. And if we
check our package, JSON, we can
see that these two have been
added. And what we can do now is
we can create a new file called
dot prettier, R C. And in this
file, we can define some little
curly braces. And here, we can
define what we want for both our
solidity and for a JavaScript,
so for example, our simple
storage has a tab width of
412344 spaces. Maybe we want to
change that. We want tab width
to be two. So we would save it
here and come back to simple
storage To save it here, and it
would get auto formatted to r
dot prettier RC. So in our
settings here, we have the
default editor for solidity, our
hard hat, solidity plugin, and
the default for meta for
JavaScript being the prettier
vs. Code one, when we add
prettier RC in here, this file
will take precedent over the
default configuration, so long
as we have downloaded the module
in our node modules, which we
can see it right here. And we
have this dot prettier rc file.
I'm going to keep the tab with
form. So we're going to update
it to that one thing that we
currently do have that I do not
like is these semicolons at the
end, so we're going to do semi
boss, and I'm going to save
this, come back to deploy it
save and you'll see the
semicolon automatically goes
away. I'm also going to add use
tabs false, since I want to use
spaces or spacing, and then
single quote, false. This way,
we'll always use a double quote,
instead of a single quote, in
JavaScript, you can actually use
the single quote or double
quote, to define strings, but
we're going to make it so that
no matter what quote you use,
it'll always be double quote.
And then for all your open
source repos, and for all your
projects that you make, you want
to make a readme.md readme files
are generally where people put
instructions or information
about your project or anything
like that. This way, whenever
anybody comes across your
project, they'll know what it's
about your readme dot MDs, our
Markdown syntax again, remember
how when we made that trial
discussion, we use some
interesting tips to format our
solidity in our code here. Well,
that formatting process is the
exact same for.md files for
markdown. They're both going to
use markdown. In fact, if we hit
Ctrl, Shift V, you'll enter
preview mode for the markdown
you'll see pound sign here in my
preview of the hard hat. This
ethers simple storage FCC is
huge. And it looks like a
heading at the top. So Command
Shift V to view your.md files or
or MIP Ctrl, Shift V for Windows
and Linux users.
The last thing that we're going
to do is we're going to deploy
this to a test net and interact
with this on a test net, we're
going to use the Rinkeby test
net. But be sure to use whatever
recommended test net the GitHub
repository for this coerce
recommends. Now looking at our
code, you might already have a
good idea of how to actually
make this slight change. Based
off of our last section, we know
that all we need is an RPC URL
and a private key and we can
begin making transactions on a
blockchain. So we're probably
going to need a rink B RPC URL,
and a rinky private key. Where
can we find both of those, if
you want to do everything on
your own, and in full
decentralized context, we could
run a rink B version of geth, we
could run it locally, and then
just connect to our guest node,
we're not going to be showing
how to do this here. However,
this is 100%, something that you
could do. Instead, we're gonna
use a third party RPC URL in the
GitHub repo associated with this
course. Go to Lesson five, we
can scroll down to get a link
for alchemy. Alchemy has a node
as a service and allows us to
connect to any blockchain that
they have support for two
alternates might be quick node,
Morales, or infura. These all
have node as a service options.
But we're going to work with
Alchemy, because it's the one
that I liked the best, we can go
ahead and get started for free
or login or create a new
account, I'm going to go ahead
and sign up with our hard hat
Free Code Camp user. And we're
going to select the Ethereum
blockchain ecosystem. Let's go
ahead and create our first app.
This is going to be we'll call
it Free Code Camp. RT hat. Our
app name will be ethers, simple
storage, FCC, and the network is
where we're going to choose rink
B. But you can see in here, we
can actually choose more than
just rink B, we can choose
really Kovan, rink B, ropsten.
And layer twos like arbitrage
and optimism, we're going to be
using rink B. So let's go ahead
and create this app. We're going
to choose the free plan and hit
Continue. We're going to skip
adding payments. If you want to
tweet your referral code, feel
free to tweet your referral
code. We're going to skip for
now. And we're going to keep it
at capped capacity. Since we
don't have a we don't have a key
in here. And then how did you
hear about us go ahead and give
me that shout out at Patrick and
Free Code Camp and then hit
Let's go. Now we get to the
alchemy dashboard, where we can
see a ton of information about
our node and different ways to
connect to the nodes and and
stuff like that. This is going
to be really similar to to this
RPC server endpoint of ganache,
except it's going to be a
connection, except it's going to
be a connection to a real test
net or real main net. What we
can do now is we can select our
our app that we just made. And
we can hit View key. And we can
see here we get an API key Key,
we add an HTTP endpoint and we
also get a WebSocket. We're only
concerned with the HTTP
endpoint. This is going to be
our RPC URL that connects to
rink B. So what we can do now is
we can copy this and come over
to our Visual Studio code. And
in our dot env, we can
substitute these out for their
actual tests and values. So for
RPC URL, we're going to delete
this and replace it with our
Rigby RPC row. And now how do we
get a private key for an actual
test set that has actual rank be
on it? Well, here is where we
can use our meta masks. So back
in your browser, go over to your
meta mask, select the three
dots, go to Account Details,
export private key. And this is
where you can export your
private key, type in your
password and boom, you now have
your private key for your
account on meta mask. Now
remember, please, please, please
don't continue with a meta mask
that has actual money in it. A
quick way to check is by going
to your networks tab and seeing
if on any of the main nets or
the networks with actual money
in it, you see any money, I
don't have any money in this. So
I know I'm good to go. If you
have tests that money, that's
fine, because that's fake money
anyways. And again, most
browsers have a profile
mechanism where you can create a
new profile for you to use. But
here now that I've copied my
private key, we can come back to
our Visual Studio code, paste
the key in here. And now I have
a private key that has actual
rink be in it. Awesome. And
remember, if you ever get low,
just come over to faucets dot
chain dot link slash Rigby get
some tests eath I'm not a robot
will send the request. Now that
we have our private key in our
rink being here, we can now try
to run this on an actual test.
Net, we look at our code, we see
we're grabbing an RPC URL, which
is going to be from r dot end,
we're grabbing a private key
which is going to be from our
daughter Yun V, which points to
our rink D Metamask. And our
rink B blockchain. So let's just
add a console dot log under our
contract deployment so that we
know what address it's at. So
we'll do console dot log, we'll
do some string interpolation,
contract, address,
contract dot address. All right,
great. Now let's go ahead and
run this. So we'll do node
deploy dot J. S deploying Please
wait, you'll notice this takes a
lot longer. Because we're
deploying to a test net instead
of our own fake local
blockchain, test nets and real
networks often will take a
little bit longer because they
need to wait for the blocks to
propagate the transaction to go
through, etc. But after a brief
delay, we will indeed see that
we get a contract address here.
And we have a current favorite
number. And it's being a little
slow again, because we're
waiting for our next transaction
to go through to update the
number and boom, looks like
we've successfully updated it.
Now something that's important
to know if ever you run command,
and you want to kill it, you can
do Ctrl C, and that will stop
it. So any command in the
terminal that you want to just
abort Ctrl. C is your Get Out of
Jail Free card and that will
kill it. That'll stop it
wherever it is. So we'll use
Ctrl C a lot in the future. So
now let's grab this contract
address and go over to Frank V
ether scan and paste it in, we
can see our two transactions
here, we can see we have a
contract creation. And we can
also see we call a store
function. This is awesome. We've
successfully deployed a contract
to the wrinkly chain using our
own code. Congratulations, this
is massive. Now on ether scan,
we actually can verify and
publish our contract code. What
is verifying and publishing your
code? Well, right now, our code
looks like a huge gerbil of
bytecode. And anybody looking at
our contract directly on chain
will just see this huge jumble
of bytecode, we can use a
decompiler to try to decompile
the bytecode into what it looks
like in solidity. But this can
often take a long time and, and
a lot of processing power. So
instead, we can just make it
much easier by verifying and
publishing the code ourself, you
go ahead and hit verify and
publish. We can scroll down and
we can add compiler information
to compile this on ether scan
and other block explorers. This
is a single file compiler
version is zero point 8.7. And
it's open source is licensed is
MIT. Let's go ahead and
continue. And we're going to
copy paste our solidity code
into this large section. Paste.
We don't have any constructor
arguments so we can skip this
section. We don't have any
libraries or any other
miscellaneous settings. So we'll
select I'm not a robot and we'll
hit verify and publish. You
might have to wait a few
minutes, but awesome. Our
contract was successfully
compiled. Now if we go back to
contract source code, we can see
all the code in here. And if we
grab our contract address, place
it into place into the search
now, and we go to contract, we
get a little green checkmark.
And we can see, anybody can now
read our source code.
Additionally, those buttons that
we saw and remix for reading
from our contract, and writing
to our contract, are in this
read contract and this write
contract. If we read the
contract, and we retrieve the
most recent number, we do indeed
see that we have seven here
because we recently stored
seven. Awesome, quick note, this
might already be verified for
you, since ether scan might get
smart enough to notice that a
lot of people are deploying the
same bytecode it's already
verified for you just go ahead
and walk through these steps
anyways. Now the code
verification we just did was
pretty simple and
straightforward, because our
code was pretty simple and
straightforward. Using larger
and more complex code can make
the verification process a
little bit harder. Additionally,
we don't always want to have to
click buttons on ether scan. To
verify our code, we want to do
it programmatically. So in later
sections, we'll learn how to
verify all of our code directly
through our code editor, you can
imagine the process is this easy
for deploying to any EVM chain
in our alchemy, we could easily
create a new app and change our
network. And you could see how
easy it would be to just switch
out this RPC URL and your
private key to work on a
different chain. This process is
also the same for harmony
Phantom, avalanche, etc. And if
we wanted to switch chains, we
would just switch the RPC URL
and switch the private key, and
everything else would stay
exactly the same. Now, Alchemy
also shows us and can teach us a
lot about transactions and about
things that are going on behind
the scenes, including a concept
called the mempool. To help us
understand a little bit more
about those transactions that we
just sent, and how to work with
Alchemy. To see more about our
transactions, we have Albert
from the alchemy team to give us
a little demonstration.
Hello, Albert here from alchemy,
I'm that guy in tech on Twitter,
feel free to follow if you want
to engage and ask any questions
about this section of the video.
But super excited to join
Patrick here to explain a little
bit of what goes on behind the
scenes when you are using
alchemy to submit a transaction.
And we have a ton of tools to
actually provide a window of
visibility into what's going on
so that you can actually debug
in case there are usage errors
on your website, or there are
pending transactions that are
stuck. Whatever it is, we
provide that window into the
data that you control. Remember
that all the transactions that
you submit are recorded on the
blockchain. They're not
controlled by alchemy, they're
not controlled by any other
service provider. We are just a
window, we're just the plumbing
the piping to be useful to you.
So let me show you exactly what
that means. Right now I have a
bunch of applications in my
dashboard. You can see here that
there are different projects
that I've used over time. This
one is the most recently active,
and it is the one that I have
currently set up to connect to
my meta mask. So actually use a
custom RPC provider here. And
let me make my face a little
smaller. And you can see here,
I've misspelled Rinkeby. But
this right now, my my network is
actually connected to the
Rinkeby test network via
alchemy. So this is actually
this application. So if I click
into here in the dashboard, you
can see here, a bunch of really
interesting statistics, this is
the first thing that you'll
probably use. If you're trying
to understand more about your
application, you'll go here and
you can see how many compute
units per second your
application is currently using.
And this is kind of great for
specifically alchemy usage,
understanding. But then this is
also really useful to see like,
what's the median response time,
and so 33 milliseconds is pretty
good. If that starts to
increase, then you might want to
figure out, you know, what's
going on here, success rate, it
has been kind of low. So that is
a clue for me to click on this
tab to view recent invalid
requests. And that I can
actually see oh, there's a bunch
of
failed transactions where the
transaction has already been
sent or the nonce is too low, or
whatever it is, I can actually
use this tab to debug. So that
success rate is pretty useful.
Throughput that's been limited.
So if you are sending too many
requests or your website is
getting spammed, you might start
getting some requests blocked.
So that's what's useful to view
their concurrent requests over
here, success rate in the past
24 hours versus the past one
hour, the total number of
requests in the last 24 hours.
And this is different than
compute units, because each
request can have a different
level of computing cost. And
computing cost as measured by
compute units. Total requests is
just the actual number of
absolute requests. And then of
course, the number of invalid
request. Cool. So one thing I do
want to show you that's
interesting is when I do submit
a transaction, and I actually
have one right here, I want to
send so let's transfer between
my accounts, and I'm just gonna
send it to tiny amount of
Rinkeby eath. But I'm going to
purposefully edit my gas fees to
be super, super low so that the
node will actually not muck send
the transaction to be mined, or
there are no miners that will
actually pick it up. So you can
see here I've divided the the
priority fee and the max fee by
a ton. So it's super low. And it
might confirm that in the MME
Max UI, you'll see that the
transaction has been pending for
a bit. And we'll go over to this
mempool tab. This is another
really useful visualization. And
what the mempool is, is a kind
of a holding ground, I like to
think of it as the waiting room
of a restaurant, where if you're
a transaction, and you're
waiting to get mined, the
mempool is kind of like the
waiting room where you're
waiting to get seated. So there
are different statuses for your
each of your transactions, the
ones that you always want to see
are the mines transactions,
because that says that your
transaction is successful. And
it's now part of the blockchain.
Now, the mempool, every node has
its own, you know, holding
ground. So I can actually show
you this quick visualization.
Remember, blockchains are run by
a network of nodes. And each
node or each computer that's
running the theorem, software
maintains a copy of the
blockchain. And as a developer,
you have to use these nodes to
make requests to the blockchain.
Now you can use alchemy, you can
use another RPC provider, you
can spin up your own node if you
want to. But regardless, you
need to use a node to
communicate with the chain. Now
each node beyond having a copy
of the entire blockchain state,
it also has a local memory of
transaction. And that's called
mempool. So if there are pending
transactions that are waiting to
be mined, you can consider them
as being in the mempool. Now
that's what we're looking at
right here. If we click on the
app that I am currently using
for my Metamask RPC, then you
can see here that there are,
this is not the right one, this
one is the right one for
wrinkling. For all the
transactions here, you can see
some more drop in placed
somewhere mind and there's one
that's pending, and this
pending, one actually matches up
with the one that is pending,
here, it's being sent to 0x, C,
BB. And if we click on this
transaction hash, you get all
the information that you need to
debug. So you can see here that
it's from my current address,
0x, five F, and then it's two
0x, C, BB. And here's the value
that I'm trying to send. Here's
the gas fee that I've attached
to this transaction. And you'll
notice that that is super low,
even for the Rinkeby test
network. So knowing this, and
seeing, wow, this transaction
has been pending for one minute
and 46 seconds, it was sent at
this time, I should probably fix
that. And so over here, you can
actually use the metamath RPC,
meta meta mask API. And speeded
up. And then I'm just going to
use the auto high speed up to
update the gas fees. And then if
we go back to our dashboard back
to our application, you can see
that there are some new recent
invalid requests. And this is
because we've resubmitted a
transaction, and then in their
recent requests we have, let's
refresh that real quick. You can
see that we are sending a raw
transaction, this one's already
known. And there's another one
before, but it that's resulting
in a get transaction receipt
that is successful. And then if
we go back to the mempool, you
can see boom, no more pending
transactions only dropped and
replaced and mined. So this
transaction nonce number five is
now successful, and you're on
your way to developing and
maintaining the rest of your
application. So yeah, thanks
hope that was useful. Let me
know if you have any questions.
Now, other than the TypeScript
portion, which I'll do at the
end, you've successfully
completed this section. And wow,
you've learned a ton. Let's do a
quick review of everything that
we've learned. Well, first,
we've learned how to create new
projects with Node js, we've
learned what the node keyword
does and how we can use the node
keyword. To run JavaScript in
our local development
environment, we learned that we
can add different dependencies
of external packages into our
local package using yarn or NPM.
And we can see those
dependencies added in package
dot JSON, we know that they've
been installed because they get
installed into the node modules
folder, we can also create a
script section where we can
minimize long commands that we
need to run into a single
keyword, like compile for
example, we can just run yarn
compile. To compile all of our
code, we learned the basic setup
of our JavaScript scripts, we
import our packages at the top,
we have some main executor
function at the bottom. And then
we have our main function in the
middle, we use the async keyword
so that our function can use
asynchronous programming, and we
get access to the await keyword,
which basically means Hey, wait
for this promise to finish doing
its thing. We're able to connect
to any blockchain we want using
an RPC URL, and then we're able
to connect our provider to a
wallet or a private key in
ethers by doing something like
this. Speaking of So we've
learned about the ethers
package, which is a tool that
makes our life a lot easier to
interact with the blockchain in
JavaScript, if we decide to,
we've also learned we can
encrypt our private keys so that
even if our computers get
hacked, our private keys aren't
lying around in plaintext. And
we've learned how to run scripts
from our encrypted keys. We've
learned how to get the ABI or
the application binary
interface, and the binary of our
code to deploy to a blockchain,
we've learned how to deploy our
contracts to a blockchain
programmatically. And then we've
learned how to interact with our
contracts programmatically as
well. Additionally, we've
learned how to add a default
editor in our settings dot JSON
of our VS code. But we've also
learned how to override those
settings by adding prettier
using a dot prettier rc file
this way, we can auto format our
code to make it look a lot nicer
and much easier to read.
Finally, we learned how to
deploy one of these contracts to
a real test net or a real
network. And then we finally
learned the manual way to verify
our contract source code. Like I
said, we're going to learn a lot
of shortcuts. And a lot of ways
to make this all a little bit
easier in coming sections. Oh,
you have done a phenomenally to
reach this section, give
yourself a pat on the back, take
a break, go for a lap, and feel
really proud about yourself that
you made it this far, we've got
a lot more to go. But you have
come a phenomenally long way.
Congratulations. Or take that
five to 10 minute break and come
back when you're ready.
Now the one thing left I want to
show you all is the TypeScript
addition to this. However, if
you're not interested in the
TypeScript edition, which you
don't have to be, then you're
done, there's only a couple of
changes we need to make to make
this TypeScript compatible.
First, of course, we're going to
change our deploy.ts and encrypt
key, we're going to change our
deploy and our encrypt key from
dot j s two.ts. And then we're
also going to swap these
requires out for imports. So
we're going to import ethers
from ethers, we're going to
import star as Fs from Fs extra.
And then we're going to import
dot TMP slash config. And then
we're just going to copy these,
and we're gonna come over and
paste them into here, deleting
or commenting out the requires,
okay, great. Now, if we try to
run Node deploy.ts, we're going
to get cannot use input
statement outside of a module.
In JavaScript, if we'd want to
use an import statement outside
of a module, we'd come in here
and do some like type module
like that. But in TypeScript, we
actually don't even need that.
All we need to do is run this in
TypeScript note. So to add
TypeScript, we're going to do
yarn, add TypeScript. And we're
also going to add TS node. TS
node is the TypeScript edition
of node. So now that we've added
that we can try a TS node
deploy.ts. And we're still going
to run into an error. And if you
scroll up, we're gonna get a
couple errors here. We're gonna
say, could not find a
declaration file for Module Fs
extra, we need to add the
TypeScript version of them. So
we're gonna do yarn at types
slash Fs extra. That, and if we
run it again, it still shouldn't
work. But for a different
reason. Yes, we're gonna get
something like this type.
Undefined is not assignable to
type bytes. Like the reason we
get this is because process dot
EMV private key in TypeScript
technically, is type string, or
undefined. So we need to tell
Typescript and and the Wallet
Objects. And the Encrypt
function is looking for a type
string, not string or undefined.
So we just need to tell
TypeScript that this will not be
undefined. So we can just put a
bang here. And everywhere that
we use process, study and be,
oops, I got to do that on
deploy, as well. Bang, looks
good. Now that we've added
everything in here, we run TS
node deploy.ts, we're gonna see
the exact same output as we saw
with just using regular node.
And as long as our private key
password is in our dot env file.
If we run TS node and crypt
key.ts, we're gonna get the
exact same setup as before. And
we're gonna get a new encrypted
key dot JSON. And that's all you
need to do to make this
TypeScript compatible. And you
should give yourself a huge
round of applause for getting
this far and learning what's
going on underneath hardhat. The
next tool that we're going to
learn and learning all about
these transactions and how to
interact with these blockchains
this is absolutely massive, so
huge. Congratulations.
Alright, so now that we've
learned about ethers js and how
to do some more raw JavaScript
coding, we're now going to move
into hardhat. We saw with our
ether symbol storage that
deploying a contract can take a
lot of code. And there's a
number of things we didn't even
do in here. Like we didn't save
where this contract was
deployed. So we'd have to go
remember where it was deployed
every time. Instead of having it
just added programmatically. We
didn't write any tests here, and
we'd have to build our own
testing infrastructure. Maybe we
want to make this a cross chain
application. And we want more
than just one private key and
RPC URL, you can absolutely work
with your smart contracts in
JavaScript purely through ethers
and small scripts like this. But
we want a more robust framework
for doing all this. And that's
where hard hat comes into play.
Hardhead is easily one of the
most, if not the most popular
smart contract development
framework out there. It's used
by massive several billion
dollar protocols like Ave
uniswap, sushi swap, and more.
In fact, I recently did a poll
on Twitter. And even though a
lot of my content has been more
brownie and Pythonic, Hardhead
was well and beyond the most
popular framework, and Hardhead
has quickly become one of the
most advanced frameworks out
there. Hardhead is a development
environment, which allows for
JavaScript based development,
kind of like what we saw with
ethers, it gives us even more
tools to integrate our code with
common things that we want to
do. It's incredibly extensible,
and it has really nice debugging
features as well. And it's just
an overall fantastic tool. So
let's go ahead and let's jump
in. If you want to follow along
with the code, come over to the
GitHub repo and scroll down.
Lesson Six heart had simple
storage, and all the code is
located here. And a quick note
for the future ever, you want to
just download all the code from
one of these repositories, the
way you can do that is by doing
a git clone, what you do is you
come to the folder that you want
to put this code in, and you run
git clone. And then you grab the
URL that you want to clone,
paste it in. Now, you can CD
into your new folder here that
has everything downloaded
directly from GitHub, but only
do that as a backup or to just
download the code yourself. But
for now, just follow along with
me. Right, so let's do this.
Let's create our next project
using hard hat. The project that
we're going to be making is
called Hard Hat, simple storage
dash FCC or Free Code Camp. This
is going to be us working again
with that simple storage
contract. But in hard hat, we're
going to show you a ton of the
fantastic tools that we can use
to make our coding life way
easier. So I'm in a brand new VS
code, and we're going to create
a new folder for us to run all
this. Now what you can do to
create a brand new folder is you
once again you can do MK dir,
hard hat, simple storage of CC.
Now we can cd into hard hat
simple storage of CD, and type
code, period. And this will open
up a new Visual Studio code
inside of that folder. Now if we
open up our terminal, you'll see
that we are indeed inside that
folder. Now if that doesn't work
for you, you can still of course
to File, Open folder and select
the folder you'd like to open.
And you'll be inside of that
folder. Now that we have our
folder setup for working with
hard hat, we can begin setting
up our environment to be
incredibly professional using
the hard hat framework got a
link to the hard hat
documentation inside our whole
blockchain solidity course, yes,
the hard hat documentation is
phenomenal. And I highly
recommend everybody have it up
as they go through the section.
Because it's going to give you
pretty much everything that you
need to know for working with
hard hat, you can simply go
ahead over to tutorial and get
started. If you want to pause
the video here and read through
the tutorial, I recommend doing
so it'll give you a lot of
information about how to work
with hardhat. And more about
hardhat. However, we're just
going to jump right into setting
up the environment. We've
already installed no Gs on
Linux, or Mac OS. And those of
you who are using Windows, I set
you up with WsL. So you can just
follow the Linux instructions.
Now to create a new hard hat
project, you can actually just
go ahead and run these steps
right here. Instead of NPM,
we're going to be using yarn,
but if you want to use NPM, you
can absolutely do so the hard
hat Doc's say run npm init dash
dash, yes, we're just going to
run yarn in it, which is going
to create a new project for us
in this folder. So let's give it
a name, which if we want it set
to this hard hat symbol storage
FF FCC, we just hit enter, we'll
give it a version. And when if
we want it 1.0 point oh, we just
hit enter. We're going to skip
the description for now just by
hitting enter. And we're just
going to hit Enter for this as
well. And for this as well enter
for this as well and for this as
well and over this as well. Just
to keep those as blanks. And if
we look in package json, we now
see we have a name Hardhead
symbol storage that FCC we have
a version we have a main which
we're actually going to delete
the main and then we have a
license as well. yarn in it just
sets up this package json for
us. Now we're going to do yarn,
add dash dash dash
of our app. So far, we've just
been running yarn add, and then
whatever our package name is.
But for most of what we're
doing, we really want to do yarn
add dash dash Dev. The reasons
for this is a little bit
nuanced. But we can see some of
the information on this
StackOverflow question here. The
main difference is that
dependencies are required to run
your project. Whereas dev
dependencies are required only
to develop. For the most part,
we're going to be doing just
dash dash Dev, when we get to
the front end portion of this
course, we'll be installing more
packages that we don't need just
for development. Now in the same
directory where we install hard
hat, you can run MPX hard hat.
So a quick note about MPX is
that the yarn equivalent of NPM
is just yarn. So yarn goes NPM,
the yarn equivalent of MPX is
also yarn. So pretty much
anytime you see MPX, do
something, you can just replace
that MPX with yarn, and it'll do
the exact same thing. If you
want to run this with NPM or
MPX, you can absolutely do that
as well. So for us, we're going
to run yarn hardhat. And we'll
see we'll get prompted to
actually start creating a
hardhat project, run yarn
hardhat. And we'll get this
wonderfully cute prompt right
here and saying welcome to
Hardhead. What do you want to
do, create a basic sample
project, create an advanced
sample project can advance some
project uses type script or
create an empty
hardhat.config.js. For us, we're
just going to select create a
basic sample project. And this
is going to give us all the
boilerplate for a really simple
hardhat project. The hard hat
project route is going to be
this folder that we're in right
now. Do you want to add a Git
dot Git ignore? Yes, we
absolutely do. Because we're
going to be using dot env files.
Do you want to install this
sample projects dependencies
with yarn at nomic labs hard hat
at a theory and waffle at Chai?
We're going to go ahead and say
yes, and I'll explain what all
these dependencies are in a bit.
Let's go ahead and say yes for
now. And we're going to install
all these dependencies. Now, if
we look in our package, JSON, we
can see we've added a number of
dependencies like nomic labs,
Hardhead ethers, not MacLeods,
Hardhead, waffle, Chai,
Aetherium, waffle, and ethers.
Obviously, we're already
familiar with ethers, but the
rest of these might be a little
new. We'll talk about those
later. And great, we now have a
sample hardhat boilerplate
project. Let's walk through what
we just installed here. The
first thing we have is a
contracts folder, which comes
pre populated with greeted
outsole is really minimalistic
contract here. Next, you'll see
node modules, which of course is
our installed JavaScript
dependencies. Something I want
to know because it was really
confusing to me when I first
started working with this is
some of these node modules start
with an add sign, and then a lot
of them don't. What's the
difference between those two,
these outside node modules are
known as scoped packages, which
effectively allow NPM packages
to be namespace or yarn
packages. This allows
organizations to make it clear
what packages are official and
which ones are not. For example,
if a package has a scope at
Angular, you know, it's
published by the Angular core
team. So it's the same thing
with this anything with AP ens
domains we know is by the ens
domains team, anything with
abnormal Labs is going to be by
the team that created hard hat.
So that's why this at nomic
labs, hard hat ethers and at
nomic labs, hard at Waffle has
this at sign, because we know
it's published by the nomic labs
team, then we have a scripts
section. This is going to be
where we're adding any and all
of our scripts that we want to
write like deploying contracts,
interacting with contracts, etc.
And then we have a test folder.
We haven't started building any
tests yet. But tests are
incredibly important for working
with smart contracts. And this
sample test folder gives us a
minimalistic test for testing
our smart contracts. We of
course have Git ignore, which of
course comes pre populated with
some important things to ignore
like Dotty and V. And also node
modules because node modules
might get too huge push up to
GitHub. And one of the biggest
changes here is it adds this
hard hat.config.js. This file
even though it's minimalistic,
right now, you can think of as
the entry point for all the
scripts that we write, it's the
configuration file that
determines how the rest of our
code is going to work and
interact with the blockchain.
Then of course, we have package
dot JSON, we get started with a
readme. Remember how the first
time we ran yarn hard hat, we
were prompted with this Getting
Started piece. Now if we run
yarn Hardhead, we're actually
going to get output of all the
different options and commands
we can use
with running hard hat. Now, if
you run into an issue where you
run yarn, hard hat, and this
pops up, but you don't see a
hard hat.config.js in your
folder, it likely means that
there's a hard hat dot config
dot j s in a higher level
folder, or there's a node
modules with hard hat in a
higher level folder. So if that
happens, maybe CD down a
directory and do a little LS and
look to see if you've got a hard
hat.config.js or node modules in
earlier folder. And because I've
actually seen a number of
engineers have a couple of
different problems here. My
friend CAMI is going to explain
A couple of different
troubleshooting tips you can
take to try to avoid these
common errors.
As a developer the most annoying
thing to deal with our
environment set of issues. My
name is Camila Ramos. I'm a
DevRel engineer at edge node
supporting the Graph Protocol.
And I'm going to show you how to
solve two common problems that
you might see when working on
this project. After installing
hardhat. And running the command
and px hard hat in your new
project folder, you're going to
expect to get back a menu of
options like this, but sometimes
you're not going to get that
back. And when you run into this
error, there is a solution for
you. And it usually just means
that you have a config file
somewhere that it shouldn't be,
and deleting it will get rid of
that error. What you're going to
do in order to find this file
that you need to delete is run
the command MPX hardhats space,
hyphen, hyphen verbose. And this
is going to spit out where this
file is if you have one, and
it's going to tell you exactly
where it is so that you can
delete it. After you've deleted
this config file, you should be
able to run MPX hardhat in your
project folder and get back that
many that we were expecting.
Another problem that is pretty
common. And I still run into all
the time is forgetting to npm
install, whenever you're working
with a repo that other people
have been working on on GitHub.
So let's say you're pulling down
some code that you and some
collaborators were working on
together, and then suddenly,
it's not working for you, you
probably just need to npm
install. So in your terminal, go
ahead and navigate to where this
project is located and then run
the command npm install. If
there are any new packages that
were installed in the time that
you weren't working on the code,
those will get installed locally
for you so that when you run the
code, it will be able to run
successfully.
What are some of the main things
we can do with hardhat in its
raw state here, these are some
of the main tasks that we can
run with hardhat different tasks
or just different commands, we
can run with hardhat. For
example, we can do yarn hardhat
counts, which will print out a
list of fake accounts we can use
with Hardhead. Similar to the
list of fake accounts that we
used with ganache, we can
compile our contracts by running
yarn Hardhead compile. Very
similar to what we did with
ethers Jas and soap Jas, you'll
see when we run compile, we get
a cache, which is just going to
be a quick way to access
solidity files, and we also get
an artifacts section. This
artifacts folder contains all
the information about our
compiled code we look in here
now we can, for example, look in
the build info and see a ton of
information about our compiled
contract. If you're looking
contracts, we can see more
compiled information. And then
if we look in the hardhat, slash
console.so, we can see more
compiled information. So all of
our compliation information is
going to be in this artifacts
folder. And whenever you want to
look to see what's going on on
the lower level when you compile
this artifacts folder is what
has everything. There are a
number of other hard hat tasks
that we can run as well. But
we'll get to them as we go. So
now that we have some of the
basics of hard head down, let's
go ahead and try doing some of
the same things we did with
ethers before but with hard hat.
So one of the first things we
want to do is we want to write
and interact with our smart
contracts. So let's go ahead and
rename greeter dot soul to
simple storage dot soul, you can
click on the file and hit enter
and should be able to rename it.
Otherwise, you can go ahead and
right click, delete it, and then
create a new file and call it
simple storage dot soul. We're
going to copy paste all of our
code from our previous simple
storage that saw into this file,
we can make sure that our simple
storage is compiling correctly
by running yarn hardhat compile.
Whoa, it looks like we ran into
an issue project cannot be
compiled. See reasons below the
solidity pragma version of the
file. It doesn't match any of
the configured compilers in your
config. Hmm, well, what's going
on contracts slash symbol
storage that's Sol zero point
8.8. Ah, okay, let's go ahead
and fix them. So we can open up
our hard hat dot config dot j s.
Now a quick note on opening
files. If you're on Mac and you
hit Command P, you can actually
start typing in the names of
files to get them to them
quicker. Or if you're on Linux
or Windows, you can type Ctrl p,
this will bring up and
interestingly if you type man P
or ctrl p and then you hit the
greater than key. This will drop
you into the command palette,
know command palette, command
palette, search for files,
search for commands in our
Hardhead dot config. Jas, I'm
gonna scroll down to module dot
exports and change this to zero
point 8.8. So that the version
that we're going to compile for
simple storage, it's gonna be
the same version and that hard
hat is looking for. Let's run
that same command by just
hitting up yarn Hardhead
compile, and awesome we see
compiled one solidity file
successfully. We should now see
this in artifacts. If we go to
artifacts and contracts. We now
see two contracts in here,
greater and simple storage and
we can see a ton of the
information about simple storage
we can also see some more lower
level in Information and build
info. Alright, so now that we
have our simple storage contract
in here, the next thing we
probably want to do is learn how
to deploy it. This is where
we're going to write our deploy
script. Now, for this section,
I'm going to be showing you how
to write a deploy script. But in
the next section, we're going to
do it a little bit differently.
But this is still going to teach
you how to write scripts and
worked with scripts in heart
app. So we're going to come to
our sample script dot j s, and
we're gonna go ahead and hit
enter and renamed it to deploy
dot j s. And if you want to read
all the comments in here, you
absolutely can, we're just gonna
go ahead and delete them all. A
quick keyboard shortcut is if
you hit Command A or Ctrl, a,
you'll highlight all the text in
your file, and we're going to go
ahead and delete it all. So now
we're just going to start from
scratch here. Now the setup for
our deploy script in here is
going to look really similar to
the setup of our deploy script.
From our previous section, we're
going to do imports at the top,
we're going to have our async
main function, and then we're
going to call the main function.
So let's go ahead and define our
main function, we'll call it
async. function main, like that,
and then we'll call our main
function. And if you want to
just copy paste this from the
last section, you absolutely
can. So we'll domain that then.
Boom, just like that. And
because of these semicolons are
going to drive me absolutely
insane. We're also going to add
prettier, and our solidity
prettier plugins. So we'll do
yarn, add dash dash Dev,
prettier and prettier, plug in
solidity. Then we can go ahead
and create our dot prettier, rc
file, we're going to add tab
with four, use tabs, false, semi
false, and then single quote,
also false. Now we're going to
be using this prettier rc file
setup a lot. So in future
sections, if you want to just
copy paste it, you can
absolutely do that as well.
We're also going to add a dot
prettier, ignore, which tells
prettier not to format some
files, which we want, we don't
want prettier to spend a ton of
time formatting all of our
files, I'm just going to copy
paste from the GitHub repo. So
feel free to copy paste from the
GitHub repo as well, you'd find
all the code for this section,
like I said, in the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
Now, unlike in our last section,
where we had to grab our
contract code a little bit more
manually, with hard hat, it's
actually a number of different
ways to grab compiled contracts.
The first way we're going to do
it, we're actually going to use
ethers. And now this is where
one of the first confusing
changes actually comes in.
Previously, we did const ethers
equals require ethers. And that
was how we went ahead and worked
with ethers. However, you'll
notice in our dev dependencies,
we have this dependency called
Hard Hat ethers. Hard Hat ethers
is a package that actually wraps
hard hat with its own built in
ethers. This is really
advantageous because it allows
hard hat to keep track of
different deployments at
different scripts and all these
other things for us. So instead
of importing ethers directly
from ethers, we're actually
going to import ethers directly
from hard hat instead. This
might seem a little confusing at
first, but just know if we want
to work with ethers and heart
it, it's usually much better to
pull it in from heart and you
can still do this and ethers
will still work the same. But
hard hat won't necessarily know
about different contract
factories in different pieces
and, and you'll see that in
action in a second. Now that
we're pulling in ethers, we can
actually immediately grab a
contract factory using ethers.
We can say const simple storage
factory equals await ethers dot
get contract. Factory simple
storage. So in order to get a
simple storage, contract
factory, we can just do await
ethers dot get contract factory.
Now if we pulled right from
ethers, the package ethers
doesn't know about this
contracts folder and ethers
doesn't know we've already
compiled simple storage dot
soul. And it's in our artifacts.
Hard Hat, on the other hand,
does know about the contracts
folder and does know that it's
already compiled, which is why
this simple storage factory
grabbing work so well. Once we
have our factory here, we can do
the same thing that we did in
our previous section and deploy
the contract. So we'll do a
quick console dot log. Deploy
flooring, contract done, and
then we'll do Kant's simple
storage equals await simple
store edge factory dot deploy
And boom, with that little bit
of code, we're already able to
deploy our simple storage
contract, then to wait to make
sure it gets deployed, we can do
await, simple storage, deployed.
And that's it. Now let's see
what happens when we go ahead
and run this deploy script. As
you know, in our last section,
we had to put in a private key,
and we had to put an RPC URL.
Right now, we don't have either
one of those defined. So what do
you think should the script
actually work? Or do you think
it'll break because we, we
didn't define what blockchain
we're going to deploy you. We
also didn't find a private key.
Well, let's go ahead and try
this out. We can run the script
in our terminal by running yarn,
hard hat, run, scripts slash
deploy dot j, s. And again, I'm
hitting tab here to do a little
auto completion and see what
happens. Well, we got deploying
contract, it says done, but
that's really it. So what really
happened? Well, let's add one
more line in here.
Let's do console dot log. We'll
do some string interpolation
deployed, contract to. And then
we'll add simple storage. That
address. Let's run this now. We
get deployed contract, and then
we get deployed contract to, and
then we get a contract address.
Hmm, what's going on here.
Hardhead has this fantastic tool
built in called The Hard Hat
Network hard hat comes built in
with Hard Hat Network, a local
Aetherium network node designed
for development, akin to
ganache, that allows you to
deploy your contracts and run
your tests and debug your code.
Whenever we run a command in
hard hat, or a script and hard
hat or a task and hard hat, we
by default deploy to this fake
Hard Hat Network. This Hard Hat
Network is very similar to
ganache, except for instead of
having this UI, it runs in the
background for our scripts. In
fact, if we go to our hard
hat.config.js, we can scroll
down to the bottom to this
module that exports section and
add more information about our
default networks. So right now,
if we don't have anything in
this module that export, by
default, it adds this piece
called default network hardhat.
So anytime we run a script,
without specifying a network, it
automatically uses this fake
Hard Hat Network. And this fake
Hard Hat Network comes
automatically with an RPC URL
and a private key for you. So
you don't even have to add one
in. This is one of the major
advantages of working with
Hardhead. It just automatically
gives you this fake blockchain.
And these fake private keys, if
you want to be a little bit more
explicit. And I always recommend
being more explicit, we can add
the default network in to the
module that are experts. So now
our default network is
explicitly stated as hard hat.
However, in any script, you run,
you can choose whatever network
you want to work with. So if I
want to explicitly say I want to
run our deploy script on our
fake Hard Hat Network, I can do
yarn, hard hat, run scripts,
deploy dot j s, dash dash
network, hard hat, this is us
telling her that, hey, we want
to run this script on the Hard
Hat Network. Hopefully, you
might be able to see where this
is going. Having this network
flag makes it incredibly easy to
switch across different chains,
different block chains,
different private keys, etc. So
we have our default network set
the hard hat here, we can add
other networks in here as well.
The way we do that is we're
going to add a networks section.
And we're going to define any of
the network sections that we
want. And remember to put a
comment there so that your
Visual Studio code doesn't get
mad at you. So recently, we
worked with Rigby so let's go
ahead and add a Rinkeby network
in here. So we're gonna say
another network is gonna be
really cool. So I should just be
able to change the network flag
to Rigby now, right? Well, not
quite. If you try to run that,
you're gonna get invalid value
undefined for hardhat config
networks. Rigby, that URL, it's
expecting you to tell it, hey,
what the URL is, since this
isn't the hard hat network, we
need to tell hard hat exactly
how we're going to connect to
rink B. And this is where a lot
of what we learned before is
going to come in handy, again,
exactly the same as what we did
before. We're going to create a
new Dotty v file, and we're
going to add our Rigby URL in
this dot env file. Just
remember, dot env is an r dot
get ignore just in case. So in
our Dotty env, we're going to
add that RPC URL from alcmi back
in here before we just said RPC
URL. But since we might want to
work across multiple networks,
it's usually good to specify
exactly what network each URL
stands for. So we're gonna say
Rynkeby RPC URL equals and then
paste that URL in here. Now, as
you probably have guessed, we
can add our URL to our Rinkeby
network here. for readability, I
usually like to add them as
variables right above the module
that experts. So I'll say const
Rynkeby. RPC URL equals process
dot E and V dot Rynkeby RPC URL.
And once again, we're going to
be pulling that Rinckey RPC URL
from our environment variable.
Of course, in order to pull that
environment variable in, we're
going to need to use that dot
env package again. So to add
that in, we're going to yarn add
dash dash dev dot EMV. And at
the top of our Hardhead config,
we're going to add require dot
EMV, and then do dot config to
enable the config. Now this
means we should be able to pull
our rink the RPC URL from our
dot env. Now that we have that
in our Rinkeby network, we can
add URL Rinckey RPC URL.
Awesome. So we have an RPC URL
for different network. But what
else do we usually need? Well,
we usually need a private key to
work with an actual network, or
that doesn't automatically give
us a private key for rugby,
because Hardhead can't just give
us test and the Etherium, we
need to have an actual account
an actual test nets. Hardhead
doesn't control those. So we
have to actually give it a real
URL and a real private key. So
to add private keys, you
actually add something called
accounts, you add a list of
accounts that you want to give
to hard hat for us, we're only
going to add one, which is going
to be our private key. And for
our private key, we're going to
do the exact same thing. We're
gonna say const private key
equals process dot e NV dot
private key. And since this
private key is going to be a
real private key for a real test
net, again, we are going to have
to grab this from our meta mask.
So it will go to our meta mask,
three dots, account details,
export private key, and we'll
add our password in here.
And then in our dot env will add
private key equals and then add
our private key. Now I know I've
said this 100 times, but please,
please, please, for learning
this, do not use a real key that
is connected to any real money
just in case, please use a new
meta mask. I've know I've said
it a bunch. But some people go
no, I'm going to be okay, I'll
be safe. Just to be super, super
safe here, please use a brand
new meta mask. So now that we
have a private key, we're going
to add it in here account
private key. And now we have an
account here. One more thing I
like to do is I like to give the
chain ID of the network, which
for Rigby is going to be for
every single EVM base network as
a new chain ID and EVM network
basically just means solidity
works on it. This includes all
test nets, there's a good site
called chainless.org, which may
or may not be going down at some
point, it has a list of all
these different networks. For
example, you can see on here a
theory main net has a chain ID
of one byte and smart chain is
56, avalanches, 4311 for
Phantom, opera 250, Polygon,
137, etc. Each one of these EVM
compatible chains has their own
chain ID, rank V, the chain ID
is for adding the chain ID is
helpful here for later on. And
we'll get to that in the future.
But for now, just go ahead and
make sure to add your chain IDs.
Okay, now that we have the RPC
URL, we have the private key, we
can go ahead and test deploying
this to an actual test net, and
actually did something incorrect
here. And we're gonna get an
error here. And I want you to go
ahead and try to figure out and
debug this error yourself.
You're ready. Alright, let's do
it. We'll do yarn, hard hat, run
scripts, deploy dot j s, dash
dash network Rinkeby. And we get
this wonderfully weird error,
which we see we have deployed
contract. So we know that in our
deploy script, we get to at
least this line, but then we're
getting an error, I highly
likely hear what's going on
saying cannot read properties
have no reading send
transaction, if you want, you
can absolutely go to this spot.
But it basically it looks like
it's having a hard time
understanding what the private
key or what the account of this
is. And what do you think I'm
going to recommend we do? Well,
if it's not clear, after doing a
little bit of triaging and
debugging, we're going to copy
this air. And we're going to
come on over to Google and paste
that right in. It looks like we
do get a question here from
stackexchange Etherium. And it
looks like it's really similar
to what we're doing. We scroll
down. They're running nearly the
exact same script that we're
running, they're using MPX
instead of yarn. They've got a
pretty minimalistic deploy file.
Let's scroll down and see what
the answers have to say. I've
seen this error where my private
key wasn't properly populated. I
would also use an environment
variable I'm pretty sure Are
environment variables good. But
we have a second one saying in
your heart head, I can think
that Jas, it should be accounts
instead of account, it works for
me, let's go back to our head
config and see if that's what's
going on. Uh huh, we put account
in this should be accounts. So
let's swap that over to
accounts. We'll clear our
terminal. And we'll run this
again. Uh huh. And now it's
reading a little bit longer,
which is good. This means that
we're probably deploying this to
rink B, which is what we want to
see. Awesome. And now we can see
deployed contract to, and we
have a contract address here. So
we'll grab this contract. And
we'll pop on over to bring the
ether scan, that's numbering the
ether scan. And we'll go ahead
and we'll paste this in.
Awesome. And we see our contract
was created about 26 seconds
ago. Perfect. Now for this part,
you don't have to deploy this to
rink be with me, if you follow
along here. That's good enough.
So remember, the flying to test
that's can take a long time. So
for this one, you don't have to
deploy with me. Alright, great.
So we've deployed to rink be
using hard hat. This is
fantastic. Now something that we
notice, once again is oof, our
contract isn't verified? Do we
have to go back through and do
this verify and publish and all
that stuff again? Luckily for
us, we actually don't need to do
that. So what can we do? Well,
back in our deploy script, we
can add some code to
automatically verify right after
we deploy. So let's go ahead and
do that. Right below our main
function, we're gonna create a
new function called verify,
we're gonna say async function,
verify. And we're gonna have
this function get past some
arguments, we're gonna have to
get past a contract, address,
and some arguments or the
contract. Since our simple
storage doesn't have a
constructor, the arguments for
simple storage are just gonna be
blank. But in the future, when
we have contracts that do have
constructors, the arguments are
going to be populated. And when
we get there, you'll see what I
mean, we need at least the
contract address, and we're
going to add some code in here
to automatically verify our
contracts after they've been
deployed. This auto verification
process works on block explorers
like ether scan, it might not
work on block explorers like
eath, pler, or other block
explorers. But if you want to
verify on these other block
explorers, I'm sure they have an
API to allow you to do that as
well. Now, ether scan in most
other block explorers have a
section on their website called
API documentation, or something
to do with API's. These are ways
for us to programmatically
interact with ether scan, and do
stuff with them. One of the main
things that we can do is we can
actually verify our contracts
through this API. Ether scan
even has a tutorial in here
called verifying contracts
programmatically. And the link
to this will be in the GitHub
repo, they have an API endpoint
that we can make some requests
to to go ahead and verify our
contracts. Now, we could
absolutely make the raw API
calls and follow the tutorial
here. But there's actually an
easier way than even going
through this tutorial here.
Hardhead is an extensible
framework, meaning you can add
something called plugins to it.
There's even an advanced section
in the documentation called
Building plugins. If we scroll
down to the bottom, we can see
some popular plugins that the
nomic labs team or the Hardhead
team has created. And also a
number of community plugins as
well. One of the most used
Hardhead plugins is going to be
this hard hat ether scan plugin
that makes this verification
process much, much easier.
Install it, you can just run npm
install bash, just save dev at
nomic labs harden ether scan,
and then add it to our hard hat
dot config. Since we're using
yarn, we're just going to go
ahead and use yarn. So back in
our code, we'll do yarn, add
dash dash Dev, at nomic, labs,
slash hard hat slash hyphen,
ether scan. Now that we have
this plugin, we can go to our
hard hat dot config, scroll to
the top and add this plugin do
require at nomic labs slash hard
hat, ether scan. Now that we
have this plugin, the hard hat
documentation has some more
information about the usage, how
to actually use this plugin, and
how to run different commands
with it. In order for us to use
this verification, we actually
need an API key from ether scan.
This is basically a password for
allowing us to use the ether
scan API. So we're going to come
to ether scan. And we're going
to go ahead and sign in. And
actually we're going to click to
sign up and create an account.
And we'll go ahead and create an
account. We'll go ahead and
verify our registration by
clicking the verification link.
And we'll click the Login. Now
that we're logged in. On the
left hand side, we can scroll
down to API keys. And we can go
ahead and create a new API key.
We call this H H hyphen sec,
which stands for hardhat Free
Code Camp. Great, this new API
key will copy this and we'll go
back to our code and we'll add
this somewhere since the API
keys basically considered a
password. Where do you think we
should add this? That's right in
our dot env. So in our dot env,
we're going to add a new entry
called ether scan API key. And
we're going to add that API key
that we just got. Now that we
have our API key, back in our
Hardhead, config, we're going to
create a new section in a module
dot exports, tell hardhat that
we have this ether scan API key,
or new section is going to be
called ether scan.
And in here, we're gonna say API
key is going to be ether scan
API key that we're going to
define up here the same way we
define these other keys. So
we'll say const, ether scan API
key equals process dot e NV dot
ether scan API key. And if
something like this pops up, you
can generally just hit enter,
and it will autocomplete it for
you, which is awesome. Great. So
now we have an ether scan API
key back in the heart had
documentation, it tells us by
adding this, we actually get a
new task called verify. Let's
try that out. So open our
terminal back up. And we'll do
yarn, RT hat. Let's see what
pops up. Wow, we did get a new
verification here. When we run
yarn hard hat harder, it
actually looks into our hard
hat.config.js and checks for any
plugins. If there are new
plugins there, it'll add them as
a new task that we can do. You
can manually verify your
contract by doing yarn or MPX
Harnett verify dash dash
network, the deployed contract
address and any constructor
arguments yourself. But we want
to be a little bit more
programmatic than this. So what
we're going to do is we're going
to go back and create this
verification function, it is
good to know how to do it via
command line so that if you want
to verify something in the
future, manually, you can, let's
build this verify function
though. So we're going to take
the our contract address and
some arguments. And for our
sake, we're going to do console
dot log verifying contract that
that just so that we know we
might have to wait for a little
bit. And in our code, we can
actually run any task from hard
hat using a run package. So up
at the top, we're actually going
to import run from hard hat as
well run allows us to run any
hard hat task. So in our code
here, we're going to do a wait
to run. And then we can do there
it thought. Now part of that
allows you to add different
parameters as well in this run.
And it's usually best that you
go ahead and add them in here so
that we're really specific with
what we're doing. If we do yarn
hardhat verify dash dash help,
we can see what parameters we
can actually pass. Well, it
looks like we can pass the
Verify parameter. So we'll do
colon, verify. If you go to the
actual GitHub for the
verification tasks, you can
actually see you can do more
than just verify, you can do
verify, get minimum build,
verify, get constructor
arguments, verify, verify, which
is what we're going to be
working with, and a couple of
other subtasks as well. The
second parameter that goes
inside run is going to be a list
of actual parameters. This
second parameter here is just
kind of the sub task, if you
will, of our verify task. And
this is going to be an object
that contains the actual
parameters. And this is where we
pass in an address, which is
going to be our contract
address, and then our construct
or arguments, which is going to
be arcs. Now normally just this
right here should be enough for
us to go ahead and use this
verify contract in our main
function, but we're going to add
one additional thing to it.
Because in practice, sometimes
there's some errors that can
come up. One of the errors that
often comes up when running a
wait is that the contract has
already been verified. And
you'll actually likely run into
this, because ether scan will
get smart enough by seeing
enough bytecode that is exactly
simple storage that it will
start to just automatically
verify any bytecode that looks
like simple storage. And then
this await will throw an error,
which we want to avoid. So what
we can do is we can add a try
catch onto this await. So
outside of the way, we're going
to add a try. And we're going to
add these little brackets that
wrap around our weight. And then
we're going to put a catch. This
is known as a try, catch and
solidity also has tried catches.
But basically, this e is going
to be any error that this
section throws. So we're going
to do is we're going to say if
this message is already
verified, then we're just going
to continue. So we're gonna say
if e.message.to lowercase, we're
going to make sure it's to
lowercase that includes already
there. If five, then we're just
going to console dot log already
verified
like that. Otherwise, we're just
going to console dot log e. The
reason we do This is because of
this errors, our verification
function will break, and our
whole script will end. And we
don't want our whole script to
end, we want our script to keep
continuing if the verification
doesn't work, because it's not
really a big deal. So I know
this might seem like a lot of
code, feel free to copy and
paste it from the GitHub repo to
just move along. But awesome. So
we now have a verify function
using the Verify task in
hardhat. Let's go ahead and use
this now in our main function,
right below our deploy, we'll do
console dot log deployed
contract two, and then the
contract address. But before we
call this main function, let's
think for a quick second. What
happens when we deploy to our RT
Hat Network? Well, remember, if
we deploy to our Hard Hat
Network, will our contract need
to be verified I need to scan?
Well, we know there's a we know
there's a rink ether scan, we
know there's a COVID ether scan,
we know there's a main net easy
scan. But is there a Hardhead
ether scan? No, of course not.
Right? The hard at runtime
environment is a network local
to our machine. So it doesn't
make sense for us to verify a
hard hat network deployed
contract on ether scan. So we
actually don't want to call this
verify function, when we're
working with our local network.
This is where these chain IDs
are going to come in quite
useful. What we can do is we can
check to see if the network that
we're running on is a live
network or it's a test net, or
it's a network that actually can
be verified, we can actually get
network configuration
information by importing a
network like this. And we can do
something like console dot log
network dot config. Now, if I
run yarn, art, hit run scripts
deploy.js. On our Hard Hat
Network, since I'm not passing a
network flag, we get this
massive output that looks like
this. Our network dot config
contains a ton of information
about the current network that
we're on, you'll see here that
the chain ID of the Hardhead
network is actually 31337 gas
price, which gets set to auto
block gas limit the current fork
of Aetherium that we're working
with, and all these other pieces
here. This chain ID is really
important. Because we can use
this chain ID to figure out
which one is a test net, or
which one is a live network. And
remember, running the script is
going to be the same as doing
dash dash network, hard hat,
you'll see our channel ID is
still 31337. Again, that's
because the default network in
our heart had config, it's hard
hat, which is the same as saying
every single time we run a
script, we're secretly running
it with dash dash network hard
hat. So now we only want to
verify on our test net. So what
we can do is we can say if
network dot config, that chain
ID equals equals equals four,
which is going to be rank B, ad.
And a JavaScript equals equals
equals is nearly the same as
equals equals, except no type
conversion is done, which just
means in JavaScript, four equals
four, and four equals equals the
string of four, but four, but if
you were to use four equals
equals equals four, this is
false. This is true equals
equals four equals equals would
be true, four equals equals to
the string of four would also be
true, but four equals equals
equals to the string of four is
going to be false. So you can
kind of do whatever you want
here equals equals or equals
equals equals. So we want to say
if the network dot config dot
Trinity is four, so if we're on
Rinkeby, then we can go ahead
and actually verify. But we also
want to make sure we only verify
if our ether scan API key
exists. So we can also in here
is site and this double
ampersand means and we can say
process dot e NV dot ether scan
API key. This is some Boolean
tricks that we're doing here,
basically, so our first
conditional we're saying if
network dot config chinati
equals equals equals four, this
section can be true or false,
obviously, right? The chain ID
that we're running on can be the
hardest network, which would
mean this doesn't equal four, or
it would be Rinckey, which means
this does equal four. But
there's no conditional on this
side. So how does this side
work? In JavaScript, if an
object exists, and you try to
cast it as a Boolean, it will be
converted to true. If it doesn't
exist, it will be converted to
false. So in JavaScript,
basically, if either scan API
key exists, if we have this in
our data in VI, this will be
true. And if not, this will be
false. So another way to read
this line here is saying if
network dot config that Trinity
is for AKA, if we're on rink B,
and our ether scan API key
exists, then do some stuff. And
that's what we're going to do
here. So in here, we'd want to
run verify, or verify function
and pass it the contract address
which is going to be Simple
Storage dot address and the
constructor arguments which we
know are going to be blank. And
since our verify function is an
async function, and it deals
with promises and stuff, we want
to add the await keyword here.
Awesome. So we've added a way to
actually verify our contract.
But we're not quite done. See on
ether scan and all these block
explorers the instant we deploy
the contract and the instant we
send the contract, ether scan
might not know about the
transaction yet, it might take a
hot second for ether scan to be
up to speed with where the
blockchain is. So it's usually
best practice to wait for a few
blocks to be mined, until you
actually run your verification
process. We've actually learned
how to do this already with the
deploy transaction. So before we
actually verify we run, we want
to run a weight, simple storage.
Deploy transaction Wait, six. So
we will wait six blocks, and
then we'll run our verification
process. Now, if you want to go
and test this out right now, you
absolutely can. I'm going to
keep going, though, because
again, testing all these on a
test net takes a little bit of
extra time. So I'm going to
finish the rest of our main
function, and then I'm going to
run everything all together.
Okay, cool. So we've deployed
our contract, we've
automatically programmatically
verified our contract. What's
next? Well, what did we do last
time, we started interacting
with the contract. So let's do
const. Current Value equals
await simple storage dot
retrieve. To get the current
value, simple storage, that's
all. We have a retrieve
function, which returns the
favorite number, so let's get
the current value. And we'll do
console dot log, the current
value is and then some string
interpolation, current value.
And then we'll go ahead and
update the current value by
doing cons. Transaction response
equals await simple storage,
that store will store the number
seven, and then we'll await
transaction response dot Wait,
we'll wait one block for that
transaction to go through. And
we'll grab the updated value by
saying const updated value
equals await simple storage
dot retrieve. Then we'll do
console log. The added value is
updated value. Awesome. And this
is going to be our whole script.
So if I can zoom out for a
little bit, I know it will be a
little bit small here, we've got
this huge main function, which
does what? Well it deploys our
contract. If we're on a test
net, it then verifies our
contract. And then it updates
the value to seven. And we have
our verify function down here.
And we have a section of our
code that calls our main
function. Now for run this on
the hard hat network. What do
you think will happen? Well,
let's try yarn, or net run
scripts. Deploy dot j s.
Alright, awesome, we get exactly
what we saw before we get
deploying contract deployed
contract to current value is
zero, update value seven. And
there's nothing in here about
verification. That's exactly
what we want. Now, moment of
truth. Let's try this on
Rinkeby. We'll do yarn, RT hat
run scripts, deploy dot j s,
dash dash network Rinkeby. And
it's gonna go a lot slower,
because obviously now we're
deploying to an actual test net,
where the blocks actually need
to be mined. And we see we
haven't deployed the contract.
Now that our contract is
deployed. We know that we're
currently waiting six block
confirmations for us to go ahead
and verify. And actually I
should add console dot log,
waiting for block the x's so
that we don't get campus weird.
Oh, wait, what are we doing now?
That it looks like we ran into
this error, no such file or
directory, it looks like our
code might not have compiled
correctly here. So here's what
I'm gonna do. We're gonna go
ahead and delete our artifacts
to trash. We're gonna delete our
cache as well. And we're going
to try rerunning this whenever
you run a script with the hard
drive command Hardhead will
automatically recompile it for
you, especially if there's no
artifacts folder. So we're going
to rerun this command and
heartbeat, it's going to compile
first and we can see that it
does exactly that. And then it's
going to go ahead and redeploy.
Hopefully this time, it should
be able to find the contract
that had just compiled looks
like this time after I deleted
the artifacts folder, we
actually did indeed get some
successful compilation. And we
can see here successfully
submitted source code for
contract or verification on the
block explore waiting for
verification results,
successfully verified contracts
simple storage on ether scan,
and even gives us a link that we
can go ahead and Command click
or control click into. And we
can see the contract indeed
being verified. This is awesome.
This is perfect. We've now got a
successful deploy dot j s script
that can deploy, verify, and
then interact with our code.
This is fantastic. This hard hat
thing seems pretty cool. What
else can we do with hard hat
like I showed you before. Hard
Hat comes with these tasks. And
the number of tasks that
Hardhead can come with can be
extended by us writing plugins,
we can actually write our own
tasks in hardhat. And in our
Hardhead dot config, it can
defaulted with this task
account, we can see task
accounts, prints the list of
accounts, and just prints a list
of accounts here actually go to
the heart had documentation to
learn more about creating our
own tasks, one of the ways that
you can define tasks is directly
in our heart head.config.js. But
typically, what people do is
they have a new folder called
tasks where they put all their
tasks. So for now, I'm gonna go
ahead and delete this section
here. And we're going to create
our own task. You'll notice that
now that we've deleted that
section, if we run yarn RDAP, we
no longer see the accounts task
in here, because we've just
deleted that task. So let's
create our own new task. We'll
call this block number.js. And
we'll use this to get the
current block number or whatever
blockchain that we're working
with. So let's create this task.
First, we need to import the
task function, we can get it by
saying const task equals require
arhat slash config. The hard hat
slash config has the task
function. To define a task, we
can now just say task, give it a
name and a description, the name
is going to be blocked number.
And then the description is
going to be prints the current
block number. Now that we have
this task, there's a couple of
things we can actually do with
it, we can add different
parameters to it by using the
dot add command, which allow us
to pass parameters to the task.
And then we could also set
actions which define what the
task should actually do for us,
we're just going to do dot set
action. And define what we want
this function to do. So we're
going to make this an async
function, that's going to take
as an input, the task arguments,
which are going to be blank for
us, and the HR E, which I'll
define in a second. Now, let me
explain the syntax really
quickly. This might look a
little bit weird, but this is
what's known as a JavaScript
arrow function. In JavaScript,
you can actually define
functions without even using the
function keyword. For example,
if we go back to our deploy
function, we have our async
function verify down here.
However, another way we could
have defined this is is without
using the function word at all,
and actually turning this whole
thing into a variable, we could
have said instead, we could say
const verify is going to be an
async function that takes
contract addresses and
arguments. And here's the
function definition. These two
lines are essentially
equivalent. There's some slight
differences between between
using the function keyword and
having your function be a
variable. But for the purposes
of this course, they're
basically the same. Which means
though, that this by itself is a
function, just not assigned to a
variable. But essentially, the
two of these do are exactly the
same. And that's the syntax that
we're doing here. You can
imagine this sort of being like
const block task equals async
function, which takes the params
and then runs that arrow
function. Or you can think of it
as async. Function, block task
parameters, and then the
function definition, these are
all essentially the same. The
major difference is that we're
never giving our function a
name, we never give it this
block task variable. This is
known as an anonymous function
in JavaScript, because it
doesn't have a name. Now that we
have our function in here, we
can now call some function to
get the block number. Well, how
can we get the block number when
we run tasks, we automatically
pass our anonymous functions,
the task arguments, which in
this one, we don't have any, but
we also pass this HR II object.
This HRV is the heart hat
runtime environment. Back in our
deploy script, this is basically
the same as this require hard
hat in here. So this HRV can
access a lot of the same, this
HRV can access a lot of the same
packages that the hard hat
package can. So we can do Hae
dot ethers, just like how you
can import ethers from hard hat.
And in our ethers package,
there's actually a number of
functions we can use like dot
Pro, biter dot get block number.
Let's save this to a variable
const blocked number equals, and
this is going to be a
synchronous, so we're going to
want to add a weight here. And
then let's do console dot log
block number. Or better yet,
we'll string interpolate this
and say current block number
like this. Now though, if I try
to run this task, you'll notice
it doesn't show up in the heart
Atlas of tasks, let's do yarn.
Art app. Hmm, I don't see block
number in here. Well, this is
because we need to add it to our
config dot config will add
require dot slash tasks slash
block number.
And in order for us to import
it, and let's add a module that
exports I'll explain what this
does a little bit later. But now
that we've required it, if I run
yarn hard hat, and now see
blocked over is one of the tasks
that I can use. Now for a run
yarn, art hat block number, we
get current block number is
zero. And this makes sense
because this is defaulting to
our Hard Hat Network, which gets
reset every time we run it. But
if I run yarn, hard hat block
number A dash dash network
Rinkeby, what do you think I'm
gonna get? Again, a much larger
number, current block number is
right here. Because this is the
actual block number of Rigby
versus the block number of our
heart ad network is going to be
zero because it gets reset every
single time, we run one of these
scripts now scripts and tasks
both can basically do the same
thing. They both can interact
with contracts, they both can
deploy smart contracts, they can
both pretty much do everything.
I prefer scripts just as a
general rule of thumb, because I
don't always think adding a
special thing from the command
line makes sense. So I prefer
scripts, but you'll see a ton of
tasks and examples out there as
well. I think tasks are really
nice for specific use cases. But
for the most part, we're pretty
much going to use exclusively
scripts, but it is good to know
what a task looks like and how
to use it. I think tasks are
better for plugins and scripts
are better for your own local
development environment. But if
you want to do everything with
tasks, you absolutely can. As
you're starting to see, this
config piece is pretty powerful.
And we can use it to modify our
entire code base and our entire
project to give our project more
functionality. What else can
this do? Well, right now, as you
can see, every time we work with
a hard hat network, every time
we run a script, we run that
script, and then the Hard Hat
Network is deleted, right? We
can't interact with our
contracts anymore. Well, there's
actually a way for us to run a
hard hat network. Similar to how
we ran a ganache network with a
user interface. What we can do
in hard hat is run yarn, RT hat
node. And what this will do is
it'll spin up a node on a local
network, exactly the same as
ganache but in our terminal. So
you see here started HTTP and
WebSocket. JSON RPC server at
this address. And just like
nosh, it comes packed with all
these different accounts and
private keys, which is awesome.
You'll notice though,
interestingly enough that this
node that we're running isn't on
the Hard Hat Network, well, we
can actually create a new
terminal to try to interact with
this just by hitting this little
plus button and creating a new
terminal. Again, I'm using bash,
but based off of whatever your
operating system is, you can be
using a different shell. And
here, let's go ahead and run
yarn arhat run scripts, deploy
dot j s, and see what happens.
Well, our typical setup happens,
we deploy a contract, we get a
contract address, we update the
value. But if we look at our
node, it doesn't look like any
transactions went through what
we don't see any locking here.
So what's going on? Well, our
Hard Hat Network is actually
different from this locally
running network here. This
locally running network we often
want to refer to as our local
host. So it's slightly different
than the Hard Hat Network. It's
still using the hard hat runtime
environment, but it's just not
this default Hard Hat Network.
It's considered its own separate
network when we're running a
node that it's going to live. of
past the duration of a script.
So we can actually interact with
this by adding a new network to
our hardhead.config.js, we'll
create a new network and call it
local host.
And exactly as we did up here,
we'll give it a URL accounts and
a chain ID. So for URL, we can
get that URL right from our
terminal, I'll put a running
yarn hard hat node. by copying
that and pasting it in here, we
can then do a comma, we'll give
it a chain ID of 31337. Because
even though it's considered a
different network, it actually
has the same chain ID as hard
hat. Interestingly enough, I
know I just said we were going
to give it accounts, but we
actually don't need to give it
accounts. Because when we run
with this localhost hard hat
will automatically give us these
10 fake accounts for us. So you
can kind of think of the
accounts here for this localhost
as, as hard had already placing
them in thanks, hard hat. But
now, if we go back to our bash
here, let's clear the terminal.
Let's rerun the script. And
we'll do dash dash network local
host. Now we should be pointing
to this node. And when I run
this script, we should see some
logging output at the end of
this node. So let's go ahead and
hit enter. Well, we see our
normal stuff on our deploy
script, we flip back to our node
Wow, we see a ton of logging
here. Similar to ganache, we can
see a whole bunch of different
logs on what just happened, we
can see a contract was deployed,
we can see the address the
transaction hash from value,
gas, and the block number and
everything. We can also see our
contract call calling the store
function to update the value of
our favorite number. This is
incredibly powerful for quickly
testing and working with things
on a local JavaScript VM or hard
hat network to be able to see
how your contracts will interact
on a real test net. And this is
much quicker than working with a
real test net. Now additionally,
same as what we said before, any
process that's running in the
terminal, we can kill it with
Ctrl C. So if you want to stop
your node and then restart it,
you can hit Ctrl. C, to stop it,
and then just up and then rerun
that same command to re spin up
your node Ctrl C stops it. And
then you can up to start again.
Another way you can stop it, of
course, is if you hit the
trashcan, which deletes the
whole terminal, we pulled a
terminal back up, we can run it
again. And just remember, if you
hit the X that actually doesn't
delete the terminal, that just
hides it. So our hard hat node
right now is still running
because I just hit it. So I pull
it back up, I can see that it is
indeed still running. But if I
trashed candidate, and then it
pulled the terminal back up, I
can see that it is no longer
running. So running scripts is
great. But what if I don't want
to have to code an entire script
to do some things? What if I
want to just tinker around with
the blockchain? Well, hard hat
comes packed with this thing
called the console. The console
is a JavaScript environment. For
us to run JavaScript commands to
interact with any blockchain, we
can jump to the console by
running yarn, hardhat, console,
and then whatever network flag
if we want to work on rink B,
main net polygon, avalanche,
etc. That's just network local
host. And now we're dropped into
a shell him in the shell, we can
do everything that we do in a
deploy script. And we don't even
have to run these imports,
because everything with hard hat
is automatically imported into
our console. So for example,
let's say I wanted to get a
simple storage contract factory.
Well, I could run exactly this
line here. I could say const,
simple storage, factory equals
await ethers dot get contract
factory, have simple storage.
And now I can go ahead and even
deploy this. So I can even just
copy this line, paste it. And if
we flip back to our node, we'll
see that we just deployed a
nother simple storage. And now
we can do things like await
simple storage dot retrieve. And
I get the return value which is
going to be a big number with a
value of zero. I can also make
transactions so I can do a
weight, simple storage. That
store let's do 55 If I hit up
twice, I can go back to the
simple storage dot retrieve.
call that function and I can see
my big number has a value of 55.
Now, this is a great way to
quickly interact with any
blockchain that we want. Now you
can exit the shell by hitting
Ctrl C twice to get out. Or you
can also just you can also Trash
Can your terminal if you get
confused. This console works
with any network we can even do
yarn, hard hat console dash dash
network hard hat. And we'll get
dropped into a hard hat network.
Now this is not going to be the
same node that's running here,
this is going to be one that
only runs for the duration of
this command. So whenever we
cancel this command, this hard
hat network gets cancelled. And
close out that too. We can also
do yarn, hard hat, console, dash
dash network Rinkeby Rigby, or
polygon or test net or main net
or whatever we want. And we can
do things like ethers dot
provider that can do things like
await ethers dot provider dot
get block number, see the block
number of Rigby. We can also
deploy contracts, we can update
contracts, we can do anything
that we want, you can do
anything in these consoles, and
they're great ways to quickly
test and tinker in interact
with contracts. Now, there's a
couple other tasks that are
really helpful. You'll see
before I went ahead and just
deleted artifacts and deleted
the cache manually. Well, to do
that yourself, you can also just
run yarn Hardhead, clean. And
that'll delete the artifacts
folder and clear out your cache.
We already know what compiled
does. But one of the biggest
things that Hardhead is
fantastic for especially is
running tests. Now we haven't
run tests yet so far. However,
running tests is absolutely
critical to your smart contract
development journey. And we're
going to spend a lot of time in
the future writing really good
tests. The reason that writing
tests are so important is
because we want to make sure our
code does exactly what we want
it to do, especially in the
defy, and the decentralized,
smart contract world, all of our
code is going to be open source
for anybody to interact with,
and potentially exploit. There's
sites like req dot news, which
go through a ton of previous
hacks and how they actually got
hacked and what happened in the
smart contract to enable these
hacks to occur. So testing, so
writing really strong tests is
always going to be our first
line of defense. And we have
this sample test.js, that comes
default with the basic package
of hardhat. But as you probably
already know, we're going to
rename this and change it. So
we're going to rename this to
test deploy dot j s. And we're
going to delete everything in
here and start from scratch. We
want to be able to test all of
our solidity code locally, so
that we know exactly what it's
doing. And we can have a
programmatic way to make sure
that our code does what we want
it to do. So let's write a basic
test for our simple storage
contract. So that we can be sure
that it's doing exactly what we
want it to be doing. Hard Hat
testing works with the Mocha
framework, which is a JavaScript
based framework for running our
tests, you actually can write
tests directly in solidity, if
you'd like to, there's a bit of
back and forth on whether
testing with pure solidity is
better or testing with a modern
programming language. The
argument goes that testing with
a modern programming language,
you have more flexibility to do
more stuff to interact and test
your smart contracts. But the
argument for testing with us
with solidity is that we want to
be as close to the code as
possible. At the time of
recording, most projects do the
vast majority of their testing
in a modern programming language
like JavaScript. So that's what
we're going to be using here. So
to get started with our mocha
tests, we do, we're going to
write a describe function.
Describe is a keyword that
hardheaded mocha will recognize,
and it takes two parameters, it
takes a string, which we're
going to just write simple
storage for now. And then also
takes a function, we could make
function, test func and then
write some stuff in here, and
then pass it to our describe
here. But the common convention
is going to be to do is to make
it as an anonymous function,
which we can create by typing
function, putting an empty
parameter here, and then some
brackets like that. So our
describe function takes a name,
a string, and a function.
Another way that you'll often
see functions in describe is
using that anonymous function
syntax. So you might see just
these parentheses, an arrow, and
then some brackets, the two of
these are going to be basically
the same, there are some
differences. And this second one
is actually best practice, but
just know that you might see
this arrow syntax in other tests
as well. We have described a
sample storage and then our
function here, which is going to
have all of our tests in it.
Inside each one of our describe
blocks. We're gonna have
something called a before each,
and a bunch of It's Our before
each function is going to tell
us what to do before each of our
hits. So we're going to have a
ton of it and then we're going
to have a before each. All of
our IDs are going to be where we
actually write the code for
running our tests. And before
each is going to be some code
that tells us what to do before
each one of these hits, we can
also actually have describes,
inside of describes, which again
have more before each and more
before it's having these nested
describes can be really helpful
for separating and modularizing
our tests. But for this one,
we're just going to have a setup
that looks like this. And for
this demo, we're only going to
have one it. So in order to test
our smart contracts, before we
actually run our tests, we're
probably going to need to deploy
the smart contracts first. So
inside of our before each, we're
going to pass the our before
each a function, that's going to
tell our testing framework what
to do before each test. So we're
going to pass it an async
function like this. And in here,
we want to deploy our simple
storage contract. So to do that,
we're going to need to get the
ethers framework and do exactly
what we did in our deploy
script. So in here, we're at the
top we're gonna say const.
Ethers, equals require art have
an import ethers from hard hat.
Then in our before each
function, we'll say await ethers
dot get contract factory of
simple storage. And we'll assign
this to a const. Simple Storage
factory. And then we'll run
away, simple storage factory dot
deploy. Cool. And let's also
assign this to a variable cost
simple. Now, since right now,
our simple storage and simple
storage factory are scoped just
to inside the before each, we
actually need to stick these
variables outside of the before
each, so all of our events can
interact with them. So instead
of having simple storage,
factory, and simple storage, be
constant variables, we're going
to define them outside of them
for each with the let keyword.
And we're gonna say let simple
storage factory and we're going
to initialize it to nothing. And
then we'll say led simple
storage. Now, if you have a
whole bunch of let's just
initializing another way, you
can write them in JavaScript,
just let simple storage factory
comma, simple storage. And that
works exactly the same. And then
we can get rid of this const
keyword. Because it's not a
constant since we are assigning
it. And now we have simple
storage, factory and simple
storage that we can use inside
of our init function. Now we
have a before each section. So
before each one of our tests,
we're going to deploy our simple
storage contract. So we have a
brand new contract to interact
with for each one of our tests.
Now, inside of the ID, this is
where we're going to say what we
want this specific test to do,
and then describe the code
that's going to actually do
that. So we're going to say it
should start with a favorite
number of zero. So this is
saying what this test should do.
And then we're going to add our
async function to actually do
that. So we'll say async
function. And in here, this is
where we'll actually write the
code to make sure that our
contract does exactly this.
We're say const. Current Value,
equals await, simple storage.re
retrieve. And now in this test,
we want to say okay, now check
to see that this current value
is indeed zero. So how do we do
that? Well, we can say const,
expected value is going to equal
zero. And what we can do is we
can do either we can use either
the assert keyword, or the
expect keyword, which we're
going to import both of these
from a package called Chai. We
actually installed Chai
automatically when we downloaded
the basic parameters when we
downloaded the basic packages
for hardhats. So at the top,
we're gonna say const. Expect
and assert
equals require Chai, I'm a big
fan of using assert as much as
possible, because I think the
syntax makes a little bit more
sense. But there will be
scenarios where we need to use
expect instead. Now, assert has
a ton of functions that are
built in that help us make sure
this is what we expect it to be.
So I can do assert dot equal
current value.to string, because
remember, this is actually going
to be a big number, comma,
expected value. So I'm saying
I'm asserting this retrieve to
return zero, which is going to
be our expected value. Now to
actually run this, we're going
to run yarn, art hat test. And
we see we get an output that
looks like this should start
with favorite number of zero,
and it's indeed passing. You'll
notice that if I were to change
this to one, and this wasn't
correct, it would break and it
would say art Pass or not
passing assertion error expected
zero to equal one. It expected
zero to equal one, which is not
what we want. We want zero to
equal zero. So let's run this
again. Tada should start with
favorite number zero, and it's
passing. Alright, fantastic. So
that's how we wrote one of our
tests, let's write one more test
just to make sure that things
are good. So let's say it should
update when we call store,
because when we call the store
function, we want our favorite
number to update. And we'll make
this an async function as well.
And let's add our stuff in here.
So we'll say const. Expected
Value equals seven, we're
expecting that when we call
store it updates to seven. Now
we can say const. Transaction
response equals await simple
storage dot store. And we can
even just pass it the expected
value here. And then we'll do a
weight transaction response that
weight one. Now let's get the
current value. So we'll say
const. Current Value equals
weight, simple storage,
retrieve. And now we're going to
assert dot equal current
value.to string, comma expected
value. And now we can run all
these tests by running yarn
Hardhead test. And you'll see we
ran both of these tests. And now
if I have 10,000 tests, and I'm
only finagling with one test, I
can actually just run one test
by running yarn, art app, test,
dash dash grep. And I can search
for any keywords in any of the
text here. So I'm going to grep
for the store function. Because
the store keyword isn't in this
tax for this, it, it's only in
the text for this it. So if I do
grep store, it should only run
our second test, which does
indeed, one other way we can run
only specific tests is with the
only keyword. So we can type it
dot only like that. And then we
can run yarn, art hat test. And
it should only run, this should
update when we call store. And
it does indeed, then we'll go
ahead and delete this save, run
again, and it should run all
too. Fantastic. Now the other
way you'll see these tests
written is with instead of
assert, it'll use the expect
keyword. So you'll see something
like expect current
value.to string.to dot equal
expected value, the two of these
lines do exactly the same thing.
And it's sort of up to you on
which one you want to use. And
that's all we're going to do for
our testing. Now. This is
fantastic, great job. Now that
we have some tests, we can
actually start testing to see
how much gas each one of our
functions actually costs. One of
the most popular extensions for
hard hat is the hard hat gas
reporter. This is an extension
that gets attached to all of our
tests, and automatically gives
us an output that looks like
this, that tells us
approximately how much gas each
one of our functions cost. We
scroll down in here, we can read
the instructions on how to
actually install this npm
install Hardhead gas reporter
which we're going to use with
yarn. So we're gonna say yarn,
add hard hat, gas reporter, dash
dash Dev.
And now that that package is
installed, we can go over to our
config and add some parameters
in here so that we can work with
this gas pit. But our neath our
ether scan section, we're going
to add a new section called gas
reporter. To have it run,
whenever we run our tests we're
going to do enabled is going to
be true. And then up at the top,
we can add it by adding require
hardhat gas reporter. Now that
we have it in here, we can do
yarn hardhat test, and after we
run our tests, it'll
automatically run this gas
reporter. So we see our tests go
ahead and run. And then we get
this output that looks like this
that tells us how approximately
how much our contracts and
methods cost. So our store
function looks like It costs
approximately this much gas and
our simple storage costs
approximately this much gas.
This is incredibly helpful for
figuring out how to optimize our
gas as best as possible. Now I
usually like to take it a step
further though. Having the gas
output it like that is nice, but
we can make it even better. I
like to output it to a file by
doing output file. Yes, report
dot txt and then my dot get
ignore like to add it in here,
but doing gas report dot txt
sentence it's not really
important for the gas report to
get pushed up to GitHub. Do no
colors is true. The reason we
add this is because when we
output to a file, the colors can
get messed up basically. And
then the biggest addition we
could do is we can add a
currency in here. So that we can
get the cost of each function in
USD for a blockchain like
Aetherium. Now in order to get a
currency here, we actually need
to get an API key from corn
market cap, just like we did
with ether scan, you can go to
coin market cap, corn market cap
API, get your API key now, and
we'll go ahead and sign up.
Choose a basic plan. We'll agree
and create my account, we'll get
an email verification. And we'll
go ahead and verify. Now in the
coin market cap dashboard, we
can copy our key. And yep, you
guessed it exactly what we're
going to do with this key, we're
going to drop it into our dot
env file, or say coin market
cap, API key equals and then
paste it in there like that. Now
that we have our corn market cap
API key in here, we can go back
to our header dot config and add
it in this corn market cap
parameter. We're gonna do the
exact same way we did above,
we'll do const, coin, market
cap, API key equals process dot
EMV, that coin market cap API
key, and then we'll take this
sticking in here. So what this
is going to do is actually going
to make an API call to corn
market cap, whenever we run our
gas reporter. This is why
sometimes you'll see me comment
this out and uncomment it
because I don't always want it
to make this API calls. But now
what we can do now that it's
enabled, we have an output file,
we can see the currency and we
have our API key, all we can do
is run yarn hardhat test. And
after all our tests pass, we're
going to see a gas report.tx T
that we can go ahead and read
from which has that gas report.
And now it actually has the USD
price of each one of these
transactions, it looks like at
current prices, with Aetherium
being $3,000 per eath, and a gas
price of 43 Gwei, the store
function would cost $6. And the
simple storage function would
cost $64. The current the
Hardhead gas reporter actually
comes with some different
options, though, if you're going
to be deploying to different
network, for example, with
binance, Polygon, Avalanche or
hecho. For example, let's say we
wanted to deploy the polygon,
let's see how much deploying the
polygon would cost well in our
WMV UHD ad token,
Matic And now we'd rerun this
test. And if we look at our gas
report that takes T will now see
the gas price of polygon right
now is around 37 Gray per gas.
And the cost of Matic is 147
automatic and USD. Now we can
see the cost of calling the
simple storage method is going
to be $0.00. Now this of course
is rounded down, but it's going
to be really, really cheap to
call store versus deploying the
contract is going to cost three
cents, I make it a habit to
select false for my gas reporter
whenever I don't want to
actually work with the gas here.
Awesome. Now sometimes when
we're working with our code, if
we don't have these environment
variables specified Hardhead
might get a little bit upset
with us. So oftentimes, I'll add
some code in here. So that these
variables are always populated,
because we didn't specify our
rink prpc URL, ring P RPC URL is
going to be undefined. And that
might throw some errors blow. So
oftentimes, what we'll do is
I'll add an or parameter here,
these double pipes mean or, and
in JavaScript, if we say some
variable equals something or
something else, what is really
happening is we're gonna say,
okay, rink, the RPC URL is going
to be equal to process dot E and
V dot rink, the RPC URL. But if
this rink, the RPC URL doesn't
exist, it's going to be whatever
else is over here. And I might
write something like HTTPS eath
Rinkeby. Example, or something
like this, just so that I don't
make hard hat mad if I don't use
rank B. And we can do something
like that for all these. So
you'll see this syntax,
oftentimes in a lot of code
setups. Now the last thing that
I'm going to show you before
going into the TypeScript
edition of This is test
coverage. And as we progressed
to this course, I'm going to
show you more and more tools
that you can use to make sure
that our simple storage contract
is safe and secure. And we take
all the steps we can to prevent
any hacks from happening if we
deploy in real life. One of
those tools is a tool called
solidity coverage. And this is
also a hardhat plugin that we
can use for our code. solidity
coverage is a project that goes
through all of our tests and
sees exactly how many lines of
code in our sample store dot Sol
are actually covered. And this
can be a Good tip off. If we
don't cover some line of code,
solidity coverage will say, Hey,
you don't have any tests for
this line, maybe you should
write some tests for it. We can
add solidity coverage the same
way we've been adding all of our
packages. npm install dash, just
save Dev, or since we're using
yarn, yarn, add dash dash Dev,
solidity coverage. And we can
then add this to our config, the
same way we've been adding
everything to our config, go to
our config, and we'll write
require solidity coverage. And
there's some configuration
pieces we can add down here
below for this, but we're just
going to use the default now we
can do is run yarn, RT hat
coverage. And this is going to
go through our tests and print
out a file that looks like this,
we'll also get a file called
coverage dot JSON, which is
basically this chart broken down
a little bit more often put my
coverage dot JSON in my dot get
ignore. And I know we haven't
actually seen dot Git ignore, do
what it's supposed to do. But we
will soon we can see here that
about 50% of the code 50% of our
statements in simple storage dot
soul are covered. About two
thirds of our functions are and
50% of the lines, It'll even
give us exactly what lines
aren't tested right now, which
we can see exactly 31 and 32 of
simple swords, outsole aren't
covered, which makes a lot of
sense, because 31 to 32 is this
Add Person function, which we
didn't call and we didn't add to
our tests. If you want to take
this time to pause and try to
make this solidity coverage be
100% across the board, by
writing some more tests, I
highly recommend you do so it'll
be a great learning exercise.
We'll also add the coverage
folder. So covered adjacent and
the coverage folder, which
again, I'll explain what the dot
get ignore folder does a little
bit later. Now the last thing
that we didn't talk about and
here was what is this nomic labs
hard hat waffle. We talked about
Daddy and V heart and ether scan
tasks gas reports. So today,
what is this? Well, we can
actually Google search this and
find out exactly what this is
Hardhead waffle is actually a
plugin to work with the waffle
testing framework. waffle is one
of these frameworks that allow
us to do some really advanced
testing, we're going to be
working with some syntax that
looks really similar to this
really soon. And we'll be
showing you more and more of
this waffle tool
as we continue. Alright, the
next part of this section, I'm
actually going to go over the
TypeScript edition of this. But
for all intents and purposes,
you've successfully created your
first Hardhead project, you've
done a ton of amazing things. In
this lesson, let's do a quick
refresher of what we've learned
so far, we learned how to spin
up our own hard hat projects.
And now we can run yarn, hard
hat and see a list of the tasks
and different things that we can
do with hard hat. We learned
that hard hat looks for this
hard hat.config.js. And this is
sort of the entry point for any
task that we run that starts
with hard hat, we learned we can
add our contracts to this
contracts folder. And then we
compile it by running yarn, art
half compile, we learned that
all the compliation goes into
the artifacts and then the cache
as well. And if we want to clean
reset, we can either delete
these two files or just run
yarn, hard hat clean. So we
learned that we can use scripts
or tasks to actually deploy,
interact and do things with our
smart contracts. We also learned
that I'm going to be using
scripts for the rest of this
course. But if you want, you
could absolutely use tasks as
well. I've asked this question a
million times what's the
difference? Nobody really seems
to know what the main difference
is. But I think the main
difference is that tasks are for
plugins. And scripts are for
your local development Mart,
that is mind limiter, we learned
that we can import a whole bunch
of things, including tasks from
hard hat in our scripts, and we
can work with our async
functions to grab our contracts
and deploy them, we actually
then can programmatically verify
them using hard hat and using
hard hat plugins. And then
additionally, we can interact
with our contracts very similar
to how we did it with ethers. We
wrote a wonderful verification
script. And we also wrote our
own task, we wrote our first
test for this whole space. And
we showed what our tests are
going to look like moving
forward. And we talked a little
bit about their importance. And
I really should stress that
writing good tests is going to
be the difference between a
really professional environment
and kind of a side project.
Whenever I audit smart
contracts, or whenever I'm given
a project for someone to tell me
to take a look at. The first
thing I look at is the readme,
of course. And the second thing
I look at is the tests. And if
tests aren't good, I usually
tell them, hey, you need to go
back to the drawing board, and
you need to level up your tests.
So tests are really really
important, especially for this
space, we learned about a couple
of more environment variables we
can use. We learned about a
couple of tools to see how good
our tests are one of them being
coverage. We also learn about a
gas reporter to see how much
it's going to cost us when we
actually deploy to a real
network. We learned a ton about
the hard hat config, and how
there are multiple networks that
we can add add to our hard
heads, we can make our project
our EVM code, work with any
network out there, we started
working with dev dependencies
instead of regular dependencies.
Now, READMEs are something that
I'm not really going to go over
too deeply in here. But READMEs
are sort of like the welcome
page of your GitHub repository,
and really should give you an
understanding of what your code
does. Being a part of the web
through space. And being a part
of the blockchain ecosystem is
really more than just you coding
your stuff by yourself. You want
other people to interact and
engage with your code and engage
with your projects. I haven't
showed you how to use GitHub
yet. But don't worry, we're
going to but if you look at my
heart had simple storage readme.
If you scroll down, usually, you
really want to have a Getting
Started section where you define
how to set up all the code and
how to set everything up a
Quickstart section, and maybe a
usage section and some testing
section, which teaches people
how to actually use and interact
with your code. Since we're just
learning more of the code part
and not so much the readme part.
For now, we're not going to go
over how to make a fantastic
readme. However, I will leave a
link in the GitHub repository
associated with this course,
link to this best readme
template. It really is a
fantastic readme template that
you can copy to any of your
projects to make them look
really good and give them a
really good setup, so that other
developers can come to your
project, and learn and
participate with what you're
coding. But all right, you have
learned an absolute ton, you
should be incredibly proud of
yourself, and incredibly excited
that you've made it this far.
Now I'm going to jump into the
TypeScript section here. So for
those of you who are coding
along with TypeScript, feel free
to follow along. For those of
you who are not, you just
finished the Basic section on
hard hit, but stick around the
next to heart out sections are
going to be the ones that really
fine grain and hone your skills,
and give you all the
fundamentals for working with
these frameworks. So be sure to
follow along with the next two
sections, we've got a ton more
fantastic content for you, we
are just beginning to get deeper
into the smart contract
ecosystem. So take that lap, get
that coffee, and I'll see you
soon. Alright, also now let's do
this with TypeScript. So I am
going to go ahead and just start
this from our JavaScript
section. However, if in the
future, you want to start a new
Hardhead project, you can
actually start a new project
with yarn, hard hat. And then do
great and advanced sample
project that uses TypeScript,
you'll add a ton of plugins. And
you'll wait a while for
everything to get uploaded. And
you wait, and you wait a little
bit for everything to get
downloaded. We're not going to
do that though, because I'm
going to show you how to convert
this to JavaScript Anyways, if
in future hearted sections, as
we're coding along with
JavaScript, if you want to code
along with TypeScript, you
absolutely 100% can. But let's
go ahead and show you what the
main differences are. Now that
advanced TypeScript thing is
going to add a whole bunch of
packages that you may or may not
want, I will talk about some of
them in our next lesson. But
there are going to be some that
you absolutely do need. Those
are going to be at type chain
slash ethers, dash v five, at
type chain, slash hard hat, at
TypeScript, at types, slash
Chai, at types, slash node, at
types slash moko, TS node, type
chain and TypeScript. And I have
a link in the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
I've got this yarn ad that you
can just copy paste, if you want
to just copy paste that into
your project to run it. Oops,
and I should have added those as
dev dependencies. So we're going
to actually just make them dev
dependencies real quick, just by
deleting these two lines, and
adding a comma here. Awesome,
that looks much better. And then
of course, what we're going to
do is we're going to convert all
of our JavaScript to TypeScript.
So anywhere where we have J S,
we're going to put Ts,
obviously, if you're coding this
from scratch with TypeScript,
you would do the.ts From the get
go. This includes our hard hat
dot config, that's also going to
be TypeScript now. And
additionally, we're going to add
a TS config dot JSON. This is
going to be our TypeScript
configuration. Typically, for a
setup, we're gonna go with
something like this. And you can
copy this from the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
It's basically telling
TypeScript, what versions of
Typescript and what files to
include for working with
TypeScript. Now let's go ahead
and start with our deploy dot
TypeScript. For usual, instead
of using require, we're gonna go
ahead and use import, we're
gonna do the exact same thing.
We're gonna have import ethers
run network, from hard hat. And
then in our verify function,
we're going to add that we're
gonna add the types for these
arguments. So contract address,
is going to be a string. And
args is going to be an array of
arguments. So we're gonna say
it's gonna be any array, because
it could be string, it could be
numbers, it could be balloons,
it could be anything. We're also
going to say for IE, it could be
any, even though this is
technically an error type, we're
just going to put any for
simplicity. For now. All of our
TypeScript scripts are included
in our TS config, or any
TypeScript files are manually
added here, which we have Our
entire scripts folder here,
which is good. So now we need to
add ethers in here. Well, if we
look at our hardhead.config.ts,
we're using require here still,
and we need to swap this out for
import for Donnie V, you can use
dot env slash config for it to
grab your dot env file. Now that
we've imported everything, go
back to our deploy.ts, we can
see that that linting has gone
away. If you want to be even
more explicit, we can go ahead
and add import at nomic labs
slash hard hat ethers like so.
reason we don't need to import
it here is because these two
packages also work with Hardhead
ethers, so they automatically
import it. But if you want to be
super explicit, you can go ahead
and add it like so. Now, we're
almost good to go. But remember,
our Harnett dot config is also
importing our tasks. So we're
going to need to update our
tasks or block number to be
TypeScript fide. So of course,
instead of const require, we're
going to import task from our
that slash config. And we're
going to be sure to export our
task from lock number as the
default. So we're going to do
export default task like so. And
now we should be good to run our
scripts. So we can just do yarn,
art hat, run scripts,
employee.ts. We can do network
hard hat if we choose. And
awesome. Now, it's when we get
to the testing, that things get
a little bit different here. So
let's go ahead and change this
required to import. Just to make
it happy there. Let's try to run
yarn, art head test, we get a
whole bunch of errors, and in VS
code will actually go ahead and
get these errors right from the
linter. One of the trickiest
things that you run into as a
developer in this space is
calling functions on contracts
where those functions don't
exist, or vice versa. We're not
calling functions on contracts
that do exist. Right now the
typing for our contracts is just
type contract, which isn't super
helpful, because type contract
doesn't necessarily have all the
functions that we want it to
have. We want our contracts to
be of type contract, but we want
them to be of the type of our
contract, because if they're the
type of our contract, they can
have all the functions that we
want them to have. So to give
our contracts the correct typing
here, we actually can use this
tool called type chain, which
gives our contracts correct
typing type chain has a hardened
plugin, which allows us to use
type chain and TypeScript
natively together, type chain
slash hard hat was one of these
things that we already
installed. And to add it to our
hard hat, we got to just go to
the hard hat config, and add it
in import at type chain slash
arhat. Now once we import that
in to our config, if we run yarn
hardhat, we now get a new task
here called type chain, you read
the description, it says
generate type chain typings for
compiled contracts, this will
enable all of our contracts to
have their own typing. So we can
have a simple storage variable
of type simple storage contract,
which is much better, because
we're always going to know
exactly what we can do with each
contract. To create this, we run
yarn,
arhat type chain. And this is
going to create a new folder
called type chain slash types.
With types for all of our
contracts, you can even go into
our simple storage sub Ts, which
is going to have all the
different functions and
everything to do with our simple
storage contract automatically
coded into Typescript and
JavaScript for us, which is
incredibly helpful. And again,
no, I haven't shown you what
this is yet. But in our dot Git
ignore, we usually want to add
type chain and type chain dash
types into our dot Git ignore so
we don't push them up to GitHub.
Now back in our test, we're
going to add the exact types of
these different objects here. So
we're going to import them from
that folder that we just
created. So we'll do import
simple storage, comma, simple
storage underscore underscore
factory from dot dot slash
types, ain slash types, the
simple storage factory is going
to be simple storage factory and
then civil storage of course, is
going to be simple storage. So
now when do let simple storage
factory which is going to be of
type, simple storage, underscore
underscore factory, and then
simple storage, which is going
to be of type simple storage
contract. And if we command
clicked into simple storage,
once again, we can see all the
contract functions that we know
and love, are here. In addition,
we have all the functions of the
actual contract itself. Once we
do that, we're pretty much good
to go we just need to have a
couple of new things here. Get
contract factory returns a type
ethers dot contract factory. So
what we just need to do is we
need to wrap this in a simple
storage factory type. So We'll
just do a little wrap like this.
And we'll say, as simple
storage, I'm just going to sort
of factory. And that's good to
go. Now that we've added all
this, we can run yarn, Hardhead
test. And boom, our test run is
normal, but with TypeScript and
with this additional typing that
makes our lives substantially
substantially better. And that's
going to be all you need to know
for TypeScript, reusable, all of
the branches have an optional
TypeScript branch that you can
use to reference to work with
TypeScript.
We've learned really just the
basics of all the different
things we can do with hardhat.
And these next few lessons
Hardhead fun meme and hard hat
smart contract lottery are
really going to be the basics
for all the fundamentals of all
the tools that we're going to
learn in hardhat. Lesson Eight
is going to be our introduction
to full stack and working with
front end and building full
stack applications. Getting all
the way through this course will
give you all the tools to start
your web three journey. But if
you're looking to just learn
just the basics, make sure you
absolutely get all the way to
Lesson Nine. And if you get all
the way through lesson 18, you
are going to know all of the
cutting edge tools for this
space. And you're going to have
the knowledge to become easily
one of the best developers in
the space. So hope you make it
all the way through to the end.
Now one of the most important
parts of this section of this
lesson is going to be pushing
our code up to GitHub, and then
sending a tweet celebrating that
we pushed our first smart
contract our first web three
GitHub repository to GitHub. So
before moving on to the next
lesson, be absolutely sure to
get to the end of this and push
this code up to GitHub. And then
optionally, if you want to
celebrate by sending a tweet,
but be absolutely sure to get to
the GitHub section, because as
I've said, many times the web
three space is this incredibly
collaborative community and
working with GitHub or GitLab,
or any other version control
tool is going to be essential
for your success in the space.
So be sure to get to that part.
All right. Now, welcome back to
the hard hat Fund Me section of
our course. This is the section
where we're actually going to
upload our first code repository
to GitHub if you've never done
this before, this is going to be
the section where we're going to
learn even more about hardhat
using a familiar contract base
we've already worked with, which
is the fund me contract. And
again, if you're using the
GitHub repo associated with this
course, you can scroll down to
the Hardhead Funmi. And all the
code is located in our repo. If
you'd like to do a quickstart,
you can go ahead and get clone
it CVU into it, and then run
yarn, and then just run yarn
hardhat deploy this, I'm going
to briefly show you what that
looks like. So in your in your
VS code, you can do git clone,
grab the package, cd into it,
and then type code period. To
open it up in a new VS code.
Once you're in your folder, you
can go ahead and run yarn. To
install all the dependencies for
working with this project, you
plan on working with the test
net or working with ether scan
or coin market cap, feel free to
fill out your Dotty and V with a
private key RPC URL, corn market
cap key and ether scan key. And
then you can just follow along
with the readme to use this repo
to run yarn, hard hat deploy.
And it'll show you deploying
some contracts and some mocks,
etc. So let's get to building
this ourselves though. Now we're
gonna make a new directory for
this project, it's gonna be the
same setup we've seen before. MK
dir, hard hat. And me, FCC,
we're gonna cd into heart at
Funmi, FCC, and then type code
period. And if code period
doesn't work for you, you can
absolutely open this up by
hitting File, Open Folder, like
we showed you before. Now, we're
in a brand new folder here. And
we're gonna go ahead and add
hard hat here. And we're gonna
run yarn, add dash dash Dev,
hard hat. Now that we have hard
hat, in our package, JSON, and
in our node modules, we can go
ahead and run yarn, start app.
And this will say, What do you
want to do? I'm going to choose
the advanced sample project
here, just to show you what's
going on. And we're going to set
this up in a way that I think
works best. So we'll go ahead
and do the advanced sample
project. Yes, we're going to
have that as the root. Yes, we
want to add a Git ignore. And
there are a lot of sample
project dependencies that it
wants us to add. We're gonna go
ahead and hit yes. But we're
going to end up not using all of
these and I'll show you which
ones we're not going to use and
why. But for now, let's go ahead
and hit yes.
All right, awesome. And now we
have an advanced project in
here. Let me walk you through
the additional things that are
in here. So we have a
traditional contract node
modules, which is going to be
the same scripts is going to be
the same test is going to be the
same. But this comes with a dot
E and V dot example already
packed in for us. It also comes
with.es lint files.es lint, RC
dot j s.es. Lint, ignore es Lint
is known as a JavaScript linter,
which helps you find and
automatically fix problems in
your code for the JavaScript
that I work with. I'm not a big
fan of ES lint, so I typically
don't use it. So I'm going to go
ahead and delete the two of
these. If you want to keep them
in you absolutely can dot Git
ignore. We're going to finally
understand what this file does
in this lesson that NPM ignore
helps Ignore files if you want
to push your project up to be an
NPM package, which we're not
going to do. So if you want to
delete this, you can as well
pretty or ignore it and pretty
DRC. We already know what these
do small hint. And so hint
ignore, which we're going to
talk about it in a minute, or
Hardhead config, which just
comes already with a ropsten
network, a gas reporter and
ether scan package dot JSON with
all the additional packages, the
readme is a little bit more
robust. And then of course, our
yarn dot lock. So this advanced
project looks pretty similar to
what we're going to be working
with anyways. Now I do want to
talk about this soul hint,
though. So what is solvent
solvent is known as a solidity
linter that we can use to lint
our code linting is the process
of running a program that will
analyze code for potential
errors. It also does a little
bit of formatting, oftentimes,
es Lint is a way to lint for
JavaScript code. So hint is a
way to lint for solidity code,
we use prettier to format our
code, and we can use soul hint
to lint, our code, they are
often used a little bit
interchangeably, even though
that's not exactly correct, as
they are a little bit different.
We can run this linter on our
code by running yarn, sole hint,
and then type the name of the
files that we want to lint. So
we do contracts, slash and then
you can just do start out so
everything looks okay, nothing
will happen. Well, let's say we
have a variable that we don't
explicitly say the visibility of
it is. This isn't the best
practice because ideally, we
always say exactly what the
visibility of some variable is.
This obviously gets defaulted.
But it's usually better to be
more explicit. So now if we run
yarn, so hint, contracts start
up so it'll give us a warning,
saying we should explicitly Mark
visibility of state, this linter
is a good way to check for some
best practices for running our
code. So we're definitely going
to keep a small hint around. Now
that we've got a repo here,
let's add a couple of our common
setup pieces here. So in
prettier.rc, we're going to swap
this out with what we've been
using so far. Tab of the form us
tab is false, semi false, single
quote, also false. We're going
to update our prettier dot
ignore node modules, package dot
JSON image artifacts, cache
coverage ID v dot star, readme,
and coverage and anything else
you want to add in here. And
we're going to scroll up to our
contracts folder. And we're
going to swap this greeter dot
soul out with our fund me dot
soul. Now let's go ahead and add
our contracts in here. If you're
following along with the repo,
you go to the contracts folder,
there's actually another folder
in here and the contracts look a
little bit different. So if you
have those contracts, steal from
remix, let's actually grab them
from remix because we're going
to make a couple of changes to
them. If you don't have remix up
anymore, which you probably
shouldn't, because you should be
taking breaks, you can jump back
over to Lesson four remix Funmi
jump into the repo here and grab
the contracts from inside here.
Just go to the fun v dash Free
Code Camp tutorial and grab the
code from there. So we're gonna
grab just fun me and price
converter dot soul. So go ahead
and delete that old file, create
a new one and call it fund me
dot song. Paste it in there. And
then we're going to create the
price converter. That's all. Now
we have both our Funmi and our
price converter contracts in
here. Now one of the first
things that we want to do one of
the first things that we did
last time was we ran yarn
compile to make sure that our
code is actually working the way
we want to. And before we
actually hit Compile, one of the
things that we're going to need
to do is come to our Hardhead
dot config, we're going to make
sure we're on the correct
solidity version. So we're going
to do zero point 8.8 here. And
let's go ahead and try to
compile.
So we can run yarn Hardhead
compile. And you'll see we
actually get an error here.
Library at chain link slash
contracts imported from
contracts slash fund me dot soul
is not installed, try installing
it using npm. In remix, we went
ahead and just imported at
chainlink slash contracts, right
from our NPM and or GitHub. But
in our local code, we have to
tell Hardhead specifically,
where to get this from, we want
to download this specifically
from the NPM package manager at
chainlink slash contracts, we
can download it simply by
running yarn, add dash dash dev
at chainlink slash contracts.
Now that we've downloaded it
into our file, we'll be able to
see it in Node modules here.
Hardhead is now smart enough to
know that at chain link slash
contracts is going to point to
that node module that we have.
So we can now run yarn Hardhead
compile boom, now we can see
compiled three solidity files
successfully. So now we have our
contracts in here and our code
is compiling successfully. We're
probably going Want to deploy
our code? Now in our last
section, I know we use the
scripts module. And we made our
own manual deploy script.
However, something that you'd
notice, the more that you work
with just raw ethers, or even
just hard hat is that keeping
track of all our deployments can
get a little bit tricky. If you
just use a deploy script, it's
not saving our deployments to
any file. Additionally, having
everything in the deploy script
for deploying can make the tests
and the deploy scripts, maybe
not work exactly hand in hand.
And there are a couple of other
things that might be a little
bit tricky to work on, we're
actually going to work with a
package that makes everything I
just mentioned, and a couple
other things way easier. And
this package that I'm talking
about is going to be the hard
hat deploy package. There's a
link to this package in the
GitHub repository associated
with this course. It's a hardhat
plugin for replicable
deployments and easy testing.
And if we scroll down to
installation, we can see we
install it basically the normal
way. They're using npm. And
we're gonna go ahead and use
yarn. So for us to add it, we'll
do yarn, add hardhat dash
deploy. And then of course,
we're gonna do dash dash Dev.
Once done deploying this require
statement to our hard
hat.config.js. Once again,
basically the config is our
entry point. This is where we're
gonna get started. And we can go
ahead and delete our deploy.js
script. Now if we run yarn
hardhat, you see that we have a
bunch of new tasks in here, with
one of them being this deploy
task, this deploy task is going
to be the main task that we use
to deploy our contracts. Instead
of writing our deploy scripts in
the Scripts folder, we're
actually going to create a new
folder, we can create a new
folder by just doing MK dir
deploy. Or you can always right
click and hit New Folder. This
deploy folder is going to be
where a lot of hard hat Deploy
Module looks to deploy code. And
it's going to be where we are
writing our scripts. To write
our scripts, we usually need to
add one more thing in here.
Since we're going to be using
ethers JS in all of our scripts,
we want to add Hardhead deploy
ethers to our package here. Now,
instead of just doing yarn, add
dash dev hard at deploy ethers,
we're going to do something a
little bit weird. We're going to
do yarn add or npm install dash
dash Dev, and we're going to
install it like this. So let me
just copy this. And you can just
copy that from the repo. And
we'll do yarn, add dash dash
Dev, and paste that in here.
What we're doing is we're taking
at nomic labs, hard hat ethers,
which we've used before, and
we're overriding it with hard
hat deploy ethers. Remember how
in our last project, we used
hard hat ethers. So that hard
hat could override ethers to use
hard hat deploy. We use hard hat
deploy ethers, so that hard hat
deploy can override Hardhead,
which overrides ethers, which is
kind of funny. When you say like
that, this will enable ethers to
keep track of and remember all
the different deployments that
we actually make in our
contract. So if we look at our
package, JSON, and now we can
see our nomic labs dashboard had
ethers. Now the version of it is
going to be MPM. Hardhead deploy
ethers. This is our package dot
JSON, basically saying the hard
hat ethers package is now
overwritten by the hard hat
deploy ethers package, which is
what we want. Alright, great. So
now that we have that setup, we
can start writing our deploy
scripts, the way that Hart had
to play works is all the scripts
that get added to our deploy
folder will get run when we run
yarn, hard hat deploy. So a good
practice is usually to number
them so that they run in the
order that you want them to run
in. So since we only have one
contract that we want to deploy
the Funmi contract, we're going
to do 01 Deploy Funmi Jas, and
in this script, this is going to
be where we define how to deploy
the fundament contract. Alright,
so we're in our deploy Funmi
scripts. Now traditionally, what
did we do, we did imports, we
did the main function. And then
we did calling of main function,
that Hardhead deploy is a little
bit different, we're still going
to import our libraries and
packages, but we're not going to
have main function. And we're
also not going to call the main
function when we run Hardhead
deploy Harnett deploy is
actually going to call a
function that we specify. In
this script here. What we're
going to do is we're gonna
create a function, we'll call it
deploy funk.
We're going to export this
deploy function as the default
function for Hardhead deploy to
look for, so we could say,
module that exports dot default
equals deploy funk. To test it
out, we can go ahead and do
console dot log, hi. And then in
our terminal, run yarn, hard
hat, deploy. Oops, get rid of
the parentheses here. Sorry. Run
it again. And we can see it went
and ran our deploy func here.
Now if this syntax is easier for
you to understand, go ahead and
use this syntax and we're going
to be passing the heart at
runtime environment as a
parameter to this function.
However, if we go to the heart
hat deploy documentation, and we
scroll down to an example
script, the syntax looks a
little bit different. And let me
just explain what's going on
here and how we're going to be
writing ours. So instead of kind
of defining everything like
this, and defining the function
name, similar to what we were
doing before, we're actually
going to using a nameless, a
synchronous function, we're
going to make it an anonymous
function, similar to what we've
seen before. So instead, we're
going to say async parameters
like this, I'm going to pass our
parameters our heart at runtime
environment in here. And it's
going to be an arrow function.
And then we're going to wrap
this whole thing in module dot
exports. So we're gonna say,
module, dot exports, equals this
async function like this. This
syntax here is nearly identical
to what's up here, we just don't
have a name for our async
function. So this is how we're
going to set it up instead. But
if this syntax is a little bit
confusing for you feel free to
use this above as the two of
these are going to be the same.
Now the next thing that most of
the documentation does is it
pulls out the variables and
functions out of the HRV that
we're going to use. HRV is the
heart hat runtime environment.
Whenever we run a deploy script,
heart hat deploy automatically
calls this function and just
passes the hard hat object into
it similar to in back in hard
hat simple storage. In our
deploy script. We had ethers run
in network come from hard hat,
instead of coming from hard hat.
We're coming from HRV, which is
basically the same thing as hard
hat. For our script, we're only
going to use two variables from
a jury when you use const. Get
named accounts. And deployments.
This syntax might look a little
bit weird for you. But it's just
a way to pull these exact
variables out of a tree. It's
kind of the same thing as just
doing a tree dot get named
accounts and HRA dot
deployments. But pulling them
out like this means we don't
have to add a tree at the
beginning anymore. And then
additionally, additionally,
JavaScript has something called
syntactic sugar. So instead of
doing this on two lines like
this, we can actually do that
whole bit on one line. So
instead, we just extrapolate
those two variables, right in
the function declaration. So
this line is the exact same
thing as doing this line. This
is an asynchronous, nameless
function using the arrow
notation, or working with our
deploy scripts here. And we're
default, exporting it with
module dot exports. I don't know
that was a lot. And another is
kind of a lot of syntactic sugar
here. But if that's really
confusing for you, just feel
free to use the above. And
whenever we refer to get named
accounts, you can also just do a
three dot get named accounts, or
a three dot deployments. So
hopefully, that's clear that
this top part is gonna be the
same as this bottom part right
here, whichever one you feel
more comfortable working with.
But alright, now that we've
gotten all that out of the way,
let's continue with the script.
So we're using this deployments
object, reason this deployments
object to get two functions,
those two functions are going to
be the deploy function, and the
log function. So we're gonna say
const, deploy log equals
deployments. So we're going to
pull these two functions out of
deployments. And then we're also
going to do const Deployer.
Equals await, get named
accounts. So we are grabbing
this new deploy function, this
new log function, and we're
grabbing this deployer account
from this weird get named
accounts function. What's this
get named accounts function,
this get named accounts is a way
for us to get named accounts.
When working with ethers we saw
when working with ethers, we can
actually get our accounts based
off of the number in the Account
section of each network. So for
example,
in this list of private keys,
private keys zero private key
one private key two, it might
get a little confusing to
remember which ones which so
instead of working like that, we
can add a section at the bottom
called named accounts where we
can name each one of those spots
in the accounts array. So we'll
do named accounts. And we'll say
one of the accounts that will
name is going to be named
Deployer. And we're gonna say by
default, the zero with account
is going to be Deployer. We can
also specify which number is
going to be the deployer account
across different chains. For
example, on Rigby we wanted the
deployer account to be the first
position, we could do something
like this or on hard hat, we
could do it like this. We can
create multiple users. Like for
example, if we wanted to do a
user for some test or something,
and we'll just say the default
is one or whatever we wanted in
here. So back in our deploy fun
me We're going to say we're
going to grab that deployer
account from our named accounts.
And then finally, we're going to
grab our chain ID for reasons
that will come clear pretty
soon. So we'll do const, chain
ID equals network dot config dot
chain ID. Now, how do we
actually deploy this fund me
contract? Well, let's think
about this for a little bit.
When working with remix, it was
pretty easy, right? We just
deployed it to a test net. Ah,
that's kind of the issue there,
isn't it deploying to a rink,
the test net is a little bit
slow. We don't always want to
have to deploy to one of these
slow test nets or even a main
net when tinkering and fiddling
with our contracts, do we know
that's gonna be really bad, we
really want to deploy to a test
net as a last stop after we've
done all our testing locally. Or
we can deploy it to a test that
to see some very specific code
work, like for example, with the
chain link documentation. So
ideally, we deploy this to a
local network first. But can we
just do that? Well, if we look
in our price converter, dot
Seoul, we have this hard coded
address in here, this 0x
address, if we go to Doc's dot
chain that link EVM chains,
contract addresses for Aetherium
data feeds. That address is the
eth USD, specifically for
Rinkeby. What if we work on the
Hard Hat Network? Example?
default network?
Hard Hat. And then like I said
before, if you don't write this
in part, it is automatically the
default network. But if we're to
point to the Hard Hat Network,
harder network is a blank
blockchain. And it gets
destroyed every time our scripts
finish, or even if we're working
with a local node, this price
feed contract won't exist, one
of the code there won't be
updated with data. So what do we
do? How do we test and interact
with our code locally? Is there
a way we can do this? Well, one
of the ways that we can do this
that we'll learn a little bit
later is actually forking a
blockchain, where you can keep
stuff hard coded. But usually,
it's still better to figure out
how to do everything with
something called mocks. There's
a great Stack Overflow question
that just says, What is mocking
and mocking is primarily used
for unit testing, which we'll
talk about in a little bit. And
object under test may have
dependencies on other complex
objects. To isolate the behavior
of the object, you want to
replace other objects by mocks
that simulate the behavior of
the real objects. In short,
mocking is creating objects that
simulate behavior of real
objects. Now, this might seem
like a lot of words. But
basically, what we want to do is
we want to make a fake price
feed contract that we can use
and we can control when working
locally. So back here, I'm just
going to leave a note in here
saying, When going for local
host or Hard Hat Network, we
want to use a mock. Okay, great,
well, we can use a mock and
we'll learn how to make one of
those in a little bit. Well,
what happens when we want to
change chains, for example, back
in dots dot chain to link EVM
chains, contract addresses,
there are a ton of different
block chains that have price
feeds on them. And on each one
of these blockchains, the eth
USD price feed is going to be a
little bit different. For
example, we're looking at ETH
USD, the address of eth USD for
Aetherium main net is different
from the address of eth USD for
Rigby, which makes sense,
they're totally different
contracts on different chains,
they have very similar
functionality. And they do
nearly the exact same thing. But
they're still different. We're
also going to need a way for us
to modularize or parameterize,
this address in here, so that no
matter what chain we deploy to,
we don't have to change any of
our code, we can always have our
code be exactly the same. And we
don't have to come in here and
like flip values and flip
variables and stuff. So let's
keep that all of that in mind as
we write the rest of this. Now
in order to parameterize. This,
we actually want to prioritize
and do a little refactoring of
our fundamental soul.
Refactoring basically means
going back and, and changing the
way your code works. Right now
we have this constructor
function, right the constructor
function is the function that
automatically gets called
whenever we deploy our contract.
Right now it's not doing a whole
lot right now it's just updating
the owner variable to be whoever
sent in the contract. But we can
actually have a do much more
than that. Since this
constructor is a function just
like every other function, we
can actually have it take
parameters, one of the
parameters that we might like
for it to have is going to be
the address of a price feed. So
let's go ahead and add this and
figure out how to refactor all
this code. So we're going to add
constructor address, price feed
for the constructor in here.
When we deploy our contract. Now
we're going to pass it the eth
USD price feed address depending
on what chain we're on. If we're
on rink B, we'll use this
address if one polygon will use
a different one b&b, different
one, Gnosis hecho, avalanche,
etc, you get the picture. So
we're going to marginalize this
like so. Now that our
constructor takes a parameter
for the price feed, we can
actually save an aggregator v3
interface object as a global
variable in our price converter,
we just create a price feed
variable of type aggregator v3
interface, which again, we're
importing from the chainlink
repo, which is an interface
object which gets compiled down
to the ABI. If you match an ABI
with up with an address, you get
a contract that you can interact
with. So we're going to do the
same thing here. We're gonna
say, aggregate Tor, v3
interface, public price feed,
ration and call this price feed
address so that these don't have
the same name. And in our
constructor, we're going to say
price feed equals, and we're
going to do the exact same thing
we did with our price converter
equals aggregate tore the three
interface
of price feed address. Like so
now, we have this price feed
address that's variable and
modularized, depending on
whatever chain that we're on.
Now, what we can do is we can
grab this price feed address,
and we can use it for our price
converter. So where are we using
our price converter? Well, just
a quick reminder, we're using
using price converter for you at
256. We're using this as a
library on top of our unit 256
type. So we're calling message
dot value dot get conversion
rate. So we look at our price
converter, we have this function
get conversion rate, which takes
an FML as its initial parameter,
which again, since this is a
library, it automatically passes
the message dot value into this
get conversion rate function.
But we could also pass in this
price feed, and therefore we
wouldn't need to hard code it in
the get price anymore. So let's
go ahead and figure out how to
do that. Well, what we can do is
we can do message dot value dot
get conversion rate, we'll stick
price feed in here. And then
we'll have to update our get
conversion rate to do a comma so
that it takes a second
parameter, because remember,
again, the initial parameter is
going to be message dot value.
And the second parameter is
going to be what we define here.
So we'll do s amount, comma ag
reg gate Tor v3 interface. And
we'll call this price feed. And
now, when we call our get price
function, we can pass the price
feed to the get price function.
And up here we can have get
price. Take, you guessed it an
aggregate or the three interface
called price feed. And now we no
longer need to hard code in the
price feed. And we can just
delete those lines and have it
compile like this, which is
awesome. So quick refresher,
we're parameterizing that price
feed address and passing it in
with a constructor that gets
saved as a global variable to an
aggregator v3 interface type, or
passing it to a get conversion
rate function, which passes it
to the get price function, which
then just calls latest round
data. And we probably could have
made this even easier, probably
could have just got rid of the
get price function and stuck
this code in the get conversion
rate. But we'll leave it there
for now. Now that we've done
that refactoring, let's make
sure it works. Yarn Hardhead,
compile, invalid value undefined
for hardhat dot config dot
networks. Let's go to the let's
go to the config real quick.
That's because the default
network needs to be outside of
networks. My mistake. Let's try
that again. I spelled interface
wrong and the price converter.
And a quick note, if gives you
an error like this, oftentimes,
you can command click or control
click and open that file up
right in the editor, which saves
you some time, we're going to
have defined the line and find
the file. But yeah, let's spell
that correctly. And let's try
this again. And awesome. It
looks like it's compiling
correctly. And we just have some
warnings, it looks like these
warnings are just about this git
version, which is because we're
shadowing this, we're creating a
new price variable down here,
you've no we just created a
global price free variable.
Let's just go ahead and delete
the get version function
altogether since we're not even
going to really need it. And we
only use the Git version to show
you how to actually start
working with interfaces. And
then we'll compile it one more
time for good measure. Boom
compiled successfully. Awesome.
So now we've just refactored our
code. So we can pass a price
feed address depending on the
network that we're on. Okay,
great. With all that being said,
let's come back to our deploy
Funmi script, and let's learn
how to actually deploy the rest
of it. In order for us to deploy
a contract we remember from our
last sections that we use the
contract factories, with heart
hit Deploy, we can just use this
deploy function. And to use the
deploy function, we'll say const
Funmi, which is going to be the
name of our contract, equals
await. And we'll call this
deploy function, the name of the
contract that we're deploying
right now, and then a list of
overrides that we want to add
here. So we're gonna say who is
actually deploying this by
saying from, we're gonna say
it's from the Deployer. We're
gonna pass any arguments to the
constructor In this args piece
here, which we just added a
single Argh. So these brackets,
we're going to make it a list of
arguments, we're going to put
the price feed address in here,
which we'll show you how to do
in a second, put price feed
address. And then we're also
going to do some custom logging
here so that we don't have to do
all that console dot log stuff
that we've been doing this whole
time. And we need to put
something in here. We need to
put an address in here. And you
can use this backslash star to
put like a common in between
your code.
We can't just do const address
equals, you know the address and
stick it in here. Well, I mean,
we could but we're not really
prioritizing now. Right? We're
kind of back to just hard coding
it here. So what can we do
instead? Well, what we can do is
we can actually use the chain ID
to do something like if chain ID
is x, use address, Y, or if
chain ID is Z use address A. So
we can do something that looks
like this. And to enable this
functionality, we actually take
a page out of the Ave GitHub. So
Ave is another protocol that's
on multiple chains and has to
deploy their code to multiple
chains and work with multiple
different addresses. So what
they do is they use a number of
different useful tricks. But one
of the main ones is using this
helper hardhat config. Now
they're using TypeScript with
JavaScript, but it's gonna be
the same thing. With this
config, they have different
variables, depending on what
network that they're actually
on. And depending on the network
that they're on, they use
different variables. So they use
this network config almost to do
exactly what we're trying to do
here. So what we want to do is
we're going to create a new file
at the root directory, so just
click down here, new file. And
we're going to call it helper,
hard hat config dot j, s. And
this is where we're going to
define that network config. And
say, hey, if you're on network,
a, use this address network, be
this use this address, etc. So
we're going to create an object
called const. Network config.
equals and we're going to add a
bunch of stuff in here. So our
main network that we're working
with right now is rinky. dinky
has a chain ID of four. So we'll
say chain ID four is going to be
named Rinkeby. And the eth USD
price feed address is going to
be the price feed address of
rank B of the eth USD price
feed. So we're going to copied
from the documentation or from
the GitHub, whatever you want to
do, and paste it in here. Now we
have a simple methodology of
keeping track of different price
feeds a different contract
addresses across different
chains. Let's say for example,
we wanted to deploy to Polygon
as well. Well, first, what are
we going to need? Well, we're
going to need the chain ID of
polygon. So a quick little
Google Search brings us to the
polygon documentation. And we
see the chain ID is 137. So I'll
do 137. What's a little brackets
here, we'll say name, polygon.
Then we'll do a comma eth USD,
price feed. And then we'll add
the price feed of eth USD on
polygon. So docstoc, chain link,
polygon or Matic and then we'll
look up eth, USD. And boom, we
see it right here. We've grabbed
this address, and we paste it
in. Well, what about the
Hardhead? Network? We'll get to
that in just a second, don't you
worry. And then at the bottom,
we need to export this network
config. So our other scripts can
actually work with it. So we'll
do module dot exports equals
network config. And we're going
to actually export a couple of
things from this file, which is
why we're doing it like this
instead of that default way that
I showed you before. So back in
our script, now, what can we do?
Well, first, we want to go ahead
and import that network config.
So we'll say const. Network
config equals require, and then
we'll import it, we'll go down
and directory to help our
Hardhead config and save. And I
just want to mention this one
more time, just so that it
doesn't confuse anybody. This
syntax here, constant network
config with the little curly
braces around it is the same is
if I went const. Helper config
equals this thing, which helper
config is now kind of this whole
file. And then const network
config equals Hopper config dot
network config. So again, this
index is just kind of an easy
way to extrapolate or pull out
just the network config from
this file. So that's how that
works. And that's why we export
it at the bottom so that we can
do this, please use the GitHub
repository to ask questions and
discussions especially about
some of this JavaScript stuff.
Alright, great. So now that we
have this network configured
here, we can now do this part of
where we say if China d z use a
if chain ID is x use y. So Since
our helper config is nicely in
this kind of dictionary, key
value pair style, what we can do
is we can say const. eth USD.
Price feed address equals
network config at the chain ID,
because if Francina D, or it'll
be this object, French entity
polygon, it'll be this object at
the eth USD price feed, we're
going to save this to eth USD
price feed address. And now no
matter what chain we're on,
whenever we run hard hat deploy,
if I run yarn, hard hat deploy
dash dash network Rinkeby. This
chain ID is going to be four.
And so it's going to use this
price feed address. If I do dash
test network polygon, and I
remember to add both ring P and
polygon to my networks, like
here, the channel is going to be
137. It's going to use this
price feed address. So this is
awesome. This is exactly what we
want. But is it everything that
we want? Those of you who have
been questioning while I have
been coding and talking, you
might be thinking, Okay, well,
you talked about this marking
thing. You talked about
localhost and hard hat. And how
do we test this locally? Like
this is how we go to a test net
and a main net. But what about a
local network? And that is
exactly what we're going to talk
about now. So we've modularized,
our code and parameterize our
code so that we're going to use
the address based off of the
chain that we're on. But what if
we use a chain that doesn't even
have a price feed address on it?
What do we do there? This is
where we actually create those
mock contracts. The idea of mock
contracts here is if the
contract doesn't exist, we
deploy a minimal version of it
for our local testing, or our
local testing. And deploying
mocks is technically a deploy
script. So what we do actually
is back in our deploy folder is
we're going to create a new
file, and we're going to call it
00 Dash deploy mocks dot j s, we
started with 00. Because this is
almost like the pre deploy
stuff, we only do this,
sometimes we don't always deploy
mocks, right, we don't need to
deploy mocks to Rinkeby, or
polygon or or Aetherium main
net, because those already have
these price feeds, we're
actually going to deploy our own
mock price feed contracts. And
in our deploy Funmi script,
we're going to use our own
contracts, instead of already
established contracts. If we're
on a network that doesn't have
any price, few contracts, like
hard hat or locos, for example.
So let's write our deploy mock
script. So the setup of this is
going to look nearly identical
to our deploy Funmi. And again,
if you want to set it up like
this, you absolutely can. But
I'm actually just going to copy
this, this part, paste it in
here, because that initial part
is going to be exactly the same.
Oh, and over here, I just
realized that we're calling this
network thing without being
defined, JavaScript will kind of
be smart enough to know where
this network thing is coming
from. But it can be a little bit
confusing. So it's better to be
really explicit, and say, const.
Network equals require hard hat,
this network thing is coming
from hard hat. And we're going
to grab this line. And we're
also going to use this at the
top of our script here. And then
our top section is going to look
exactly the same as well, we're
going to grab these three lines,
and paste them in deploy
deployer chain ID, boom, it's
all going to be the same here,
because we're setting up to
deploy some stuff. Now we want
to deploy a new contract. But if
we look at our contracts folder,
this is all we have right now.
So we're going to need to add
this mock this fake contract to
our contracts folder. Now what
we can do is in our contracts
folder, we want to separate this
file from the rest of our file
so that we know okay, this isn't
part of our project, but it is
part of our testing. So we're
going to right click Create New
Folder. And we can either call
it mocks, or test I like to call
mine test. And inside of this
folder, we can go ahead and
right click create a new file,
I'm going to create a new file
and call it mock, v3 aggregate
tore that soul. And this is
where we're going to define our
mock price feed aggregator
ourselves. So how can we create
our own fake price feed
contract, so we can test
everything locally? Well, one
thing we could do is we go to
the chain link GitHub repo, and
go through the contracts and
find one of these price feed
addresses, source eight, or
maybe we'll go back to source
we'll maybe we'll check in V
six.
Looks like we could find some
stuff and look around and we
probably copy paste all this
code, but it really seems like
kind of a huge pain in the butt
to have to copy all this code.
Now we absolutely could we copy
paste the code in here, but
we're gonna do something a
little bit more clever. So the
chainlink repo actually comes
with some mocks. If we go to
contracts, SRC V 0.6 tests They
actually have a mock v3
aggregator dot soul in here that
we can use as our mock. So we
can copy paste everything, but
we'd have to revamp a little bit
of it because it's doing some
dot dot stuff. It's talking to
other contracts that are locally
in this file structure that are
not going to be in our file
structure. So instead though,
what we can do is we can use
this node modules package to our
advantage, we can just say
pragma, solidity, carrot zero,
point 6.0, we'll use the same
version that that package is
doing. And then just do import
at a chain link slash contracts
slash SRC slash v 0.6. Slash
tests slash mock, B, three egg,
Reg, gay tore that soul. And
then we'll add, and then of
course, we'll add spdx, license
identifier, MIT. And boom, this
is actually all we need. If we
just import the code like this,
remember, this is exactly the
same as copy pasting this
contract into our project, of
course, with this path resolve
to where it actually is in our
node modules. Now, actually, I
can run yarn hardhat compile,
and it will also compile this
contract. Except for of course,
we have an issue, hey, compiler
versions don't match. Right?
What's What's up with that now,
you're going to get into
situations where you will be
working with contracts that are
not the same version of solidity
as you why well because
contracts keep being deployed
all the time. And there are a
ton of contracts that are in
version 0.4, solidity,
0.5 0.678, and probably 910, or
15 billion, or however many
solidity versions will come to
be. So in our config, in our
hard hat dot config, when you
scroll to the bottom, we can
scroll to where we're defining
our solidity version. And we can
actually add multiple solidity
versions, so that our compiler
can compile multiple versions of
solidity. To do that, we'll say,
so Lyd, did T. And we'll turn it
into an object here, we'll make
sure to put this comma here. And
inside our solidity object,
we'll put compilers and we'll
have a list of compilers. Our
first one we'll say is version,
zero, point 8.8. And we'll say
our second one is going to be
version 0.6, point six, and then
we'll go ahead and save that.
And it looks like mine wanted to
format it like this, which is
fine. Now, we can go ahead,
rerun, yarn, Hardhead, compile,
and boom, compiled five solidity
files successfully. This means
that our Mark V aggregator
should also have been compiled.
And if we look in artifacts, at
chain link, do indeed see this
at chain link slash contract
slash SRC bid, and a v 0.6. In
tests, we see this mock
aggregator dot soul, which has
been compiled. Awesome. So now
that we have our mock contract
compiled, we now have a contract
that we can use to deploy a fake
price feed to a blockchain. So
how do we actually do this?
Well, it's going to be the exact
same way that we deployed the
Funmi contract. But we're going
to add a little if statement in
here, we don't want to deploy
this mock contract to a test net
or a network that actually has a
price feed on it, we could just
do something like if chain ID
does not equal, you know, some
chain ID, then deploy marks,
right. And then this is kind of
pseudocode. Obviously, this code
won't actually work. But
instead, what I like is I
actually like to specify which
chains are going to be my
development chains, which chains
are going to be the one that I
can deploy these mocks to, in my
helper, hard hat config, I'll
define these chains. So I'll say
const, development chains,
equals, and then I'll just say
hard hat, and local host. I'll
export these. And back in my
deploy mocks, I'll import these
with const. Development chains
equals require dot dot slash
helper Hardhead config. And now
I'll say if development chains
dot includes chain ID. This
includes keyword basically is a
function that checks to see if
some variable is inside an
array, then we're gonna go ahead
and deploy Max, and which is
what we want to do. So we'll do
log, which we're getting from
deployments, which is basically
console dot log. And we'll say
local network detected,
deploying mocks.
And we'll do a weight ploy, and
we'll deploy our new mock v3
aggregator mock v3 aggregator
will do a comma. There a little
colons here. If we want to get
really specific, we can say
contract v3 aggregator which
we're kind of already saying
we'll say from deployer We'll
say logging is going to be true.
And then we need to pass some
arguments, we need to pass the
constructor parameters for the
mock v3 aggregator, which are
what? Well, let's go to docs
chain to link to find out. Or
you can also just go to Node
modules chainlink, SRC V 06,
tests, and then all the way down
to mock V three, aggregated out.
So where you could also find the
constructor in here, whatever
one you like better, sometimes I
find it easier just to read
GitHub Ctrl plus F or Command
plus F for constructor. We see
it takes a decimals and an
initial answer. And if we read
through the code, we'll learn
that the decimals object is
going to be equivalent to the
decimals parameter is going to
be equivalent to this decimals
function and the initial answer.
And the initial answer is
basically just going to be what
is the price feed starting at,
we actually get to pick the
price of the price feed, which
works out really well, because
that works out great for
testing. I usually like to
define the decimals and the
initial answers somewhere
outside of this function so that
I can access it later. One good
place you can add it is once
again in our helper Hardhead
config.js. So I might do const
decimals equals eight. And then
const initial answer. Answer
equals, and we'll do 2000. So
since we have a decimals, we'll
do 2000 And then 123456788
decimal places, and then we'll
export these as well. Export
decimals, and export initial
answer. We could of course, just
do you know, const decimals
equals eight at the top and then
initial answer and then use them
down here. But I like to do it
like that. So Conce. So now we
have to import them in here.
const development chains. It's
also grabbed decimals. It's also
grabbed initial answer, we'll
save it. We'll take a look back
at the constructor looks like
it's decimals first, initial
answers second. So in our
arguments, we'll do decimals
first, initial answers second,
and tada. And then we will be
all done that we'll do a quick
log box deployed. And then I
also like to do kind of like a
big line at the end of all of my
deploy scripts just to be like,
hey, that's the end of this
deploy script. Anything else
after this is going to be a
different deploy script. All
right, great. Now our deployed
mocks script is actually done.
But our deploy Funmi script
isn't quite done. Is there a way
that we could run only our
deploy mock script? Well, yes,
there is. Great, thanks for
asking. What we can do at the
bottom of our deploy mock script
is we can add a module that
exports dot tags, equals, and
we'll say all and marks. Now
what we can do is if we run
yarn, hard hat deploy, we can
add this flag dash dash tags.
And it will only run the deploy
scripts that have a special tag.
So we'll run our mocks tag,
which means it'll only run our
deploy mock script. And, and
oops, actually, in our helper
config development chains is
actually hard hat and localhost.
And I said, we're going to try
to do with the chain ID, sorry,
we're going to do this, we're
gonna do development chains dot
includes network dot name.
Because our helper config is
using names and not chain IDs,
so if development chains that
includes that network the names,
then we're gonna go ahead and
deploy the mocks. So let's go
ahead and run this yarn here and
hit Deploy dash dash tags,
mocks. And perfect we do indeed
see our mocks getting deployed
here. This log true means that
it's going to spit out stuff
like this. It'll say contract,
it's deploying, it'll say the
transaction it's doing and it'll
say where it was deployed with
how much gas and awesome This
means our deployed Mach script
is working perfectly. So now we
have our deploy mocks script
working perfectly. So how do we
apply that back to our deploy
Funmi script? Well, we're gonna
do the exact same thing here.
Instead of making eth USD price
feed address constant variable,
we're gonna say let at USD price
you'd variable so that we can
actually update it. And we'll
say, if development chains dot
includes network dot name, what
we can do with hard hat deploy
is we can just get the most
recent deployment using a
command called literally get. So
we'll say const. eth USD
aggregator equals await
deployments dot get. And then
the name of the contract that we
deployed Mach v3 aggregator, and
if you wanted to just do get
instead of deployments dot get,
we absolutely could, just by
doing it like this. Those are
exactly the same. So we'll get
the address like this and then
we'll say eth USD price feed
address equals that eth USD
aggregator contract dot address.
And then if we're not on a
development chain, if we didn't
deploy a mock, we're just going
to do exactly what we did
before. With using the network
config. Oh, my goodness. Now,
now that we've done all of these
steps, let's add a little log
thing at the bottom here with
just a bunch of hyphens. Now, we
should have a very robust script
to flip between a local
development chain, a test net
chain, a main net chain, and
allow us to deploy literally
everywhere without changing any
of our solidity. And then we
just take this, this eth USD
price feed address and stick it
into logs here. And then at the
bottom, we can do module dot
exports, dot tags equals and
then we'll just do all and then
we'll call this one Funmi. Oh,
now moment of truth. If we did
all this, right, we should just
be able to run yarn, hard hat
deploy. And it should work on
our local chain, our hard hat
chain. And then it should also
work on any test net that we
give it. So let's give this a
try. Yarn, Hardhead deploy.
Let's see if this works.
Awesome. And we got this all to
deploy locally to our Hard Hat
Network, we can see that we went
ahead and we deployed mocks, we
did our little underline here.
And then we deployed Funmi
deployed at this address with
this much gas. Now, what are the
other awesome things about hard
hat deploy? When we run our
local blockchain, our own
blockchain node, hard hat deploy
will automatically run through
all of our deploy scripts and
add them to our node. So now if
I run yarn, hard hat node, we're
going to spin up a new
blockchain node, but it's
already going to have all of our
deployed contracts on it. So
every time we spin up a local
node, now it's going to come
automatically packed with the
contracts that we want on it. So
we are going to show us doing
this on a test net on Rinkeby.
But before we actually test it
on Rinkeby, I'm going to add a
little bit of the auto
verification piece in here as
well, because we did that in the
last lesson. And we wanted to
show how to do it in hard hat
deploy as well. So right after
we deploy our Funmi, we can do
something similar here, we'll
say, if developer chains
includes network dot name, we'll
say if developer chains doesn't
include network dot name,
because we don't want to verify
on a local network. So we'll say
if not development chains dot
includes network dot name, the
exclamation mark, aka the bang
means not when we're talking
about booleans. So we're saying,
if the name of the network isn't
a development chain, we want to
go ahead and verify and same as
last time. And if process dot e
NV dot ether scan API key,
then we're going to go ahead and
verify. Now before we had our
verify code, right in our deploy
code, we're gonna do something a
little bit different here.
Instead of having our verify
code in our deploy scripts here,
we're actually going to create a
new folder called utils, which
stands for utilities. And this
is where we're going to add
different scripts that we can
use across different
deployments. Because let's say
we have 50 Deploy scripts, we're
not going to make 50 Deploy
functions, we're just going to
add them to our utils folder,
and in our utils folder, or
create a new file called verify
dot j s, we're going to add that
code from our last project in
here. So if you want, you can go
ahead copy paste from our last
project over to this one, or you
can pause the video to type it
out yourself. Since we're using
the run command here, we're
gonna do const run equals
require RT hat. And then at the
bottom, we're going to do module
exports. Exports equals verify.
Now that we have a verify script
in our utils folder, back in our
deploy Funmi we're going to say
const. Verify equals require dot
dot slash utils. Slash verify.
And since now in our verified
Jas, we have a lot of this
trycatch stuff in here, we can
just do a wait. Verify and a
verify once again takes a
contract address and a list of
arguments. We'll say await
verify, fund me dot address and
then the list of arguments. To
make the list of arguments
easier to put in. You can go
const args, equals and then
we'll just stick our eth USD
price feed in here and then
replace this with args and then
take this args and pop it on
down into the second parameter
here. All right, great. Now
let's go ahead and deploy this
to With the Rinkeby test net,
and what do we need to deploy
this to the Rinkeby test net?
Well, let's jump into our hard
hat config first. And let's
clean this up, we don't really
need this accounts task, so I'm
just going to delete it, I don't
really need this comment. So I'm
going to delete this too. And
let's jump into the network
section, we're not going to be
working with ropsten. So we're
gonna go ahead and dump that. We
are however, going to be working
with rink B, the URL is going to
be that same Rinkeby RPC URL. So
we're going to define that up
here, like we did before. And if
you want to copy paste from your
last project, feel free to do so
you can also follow along with
me or fastforward me the counts
is going to be the same. I'm
going to go ahead and just copy
paste the gas reporter with what
we had from before. So we're
going to add this constant corn
market cap API key equals
process dot EMV dot corn market
cap API key. Do the same thing
with the ether scan API key
Licious add everything in here.
Now. We have our ether scan
section in here already, we're
gonna have our gas reporter be
false, because I don't really
feel like using it right now.
And then finally, we're going to
add one more thing in here.
Remember how in our last
project, before we actually
verified we waited some block
confirmations. That way ether
scan could make sure to catch
up. Well, we can do the exact
same thing in here in our hard
hat dot config, we can add a
section for each test net for
how many blocks we want to wait,
I'm going to add block
confirmations of six. Now back
on our deploy Funmi. In a new
section, I can add wait
confirmations of network dot
config. That block on for
motions, or one is or one means
if no block confirmations is
given in our Hardhead dot config
will just wait for one block.
And again, the reason we want to
wait for approximately six block
confirmations is we want to give
ether scan a chance to index our
transaction. And I added a chain
ID 42 when it should be for my
mistake. And of course, we're
going to need our dot env file,
where we add all of our stuff
from the last session, the RIP
ERP CRL private key ether scan
API and then coin market cap
API. All right moment of truth.
Let's try this out. If we run
yarn Hardhead deploy dash dash
network Rinkeby. It should not
deploy any marks because we have
this if statement in our mock
deployment. But it should deploy
our Funmi contract using the
correct price feed address. And
then it'll go ahead and verify
it. Since we're waiting for six
block confirmations, we can even
be super secure by adding dash
dash tags and just running the
funding tag. But we're just
going to do yarn hearted deploy
network Rigby. And let's see
what happens. All right, and
we're deploying funding. And we
can see the transaction that we
have for fun me, this is that
logging feature, we have log is
true for deploying Funmi. So it
gives us the transaction once it
has a transaction, and it will
give us the address once we have
the address. So we're going to
wait six block confirmations for
this transaction to finish going
through. Now we see we've
deployed this contract address
with X amount of gas. And now
we're running the verification
process. While the verification
process is running, we can pull
up Rinkeby ether scan, paste our
address in here and see that we
have indeed created this
contract. And now it looks like
we've successfully verified the
contract on ether scan. So if we
hit refresh, we can indeed see
that the contract has been
verified. Awesome. All right. So
this is fantastic. Our deploy
script is looking great, we're
able to deploy to a local chain,
we're able to deploy to a test
that and if we wanted to, we
could deploy to any network that
we wanted simply by updating our
hard hat config, and then
updating our helper config. This
is fantastic.
Great work so far. Now we're
about to jump in and level up
our tests. But before we do
that, we're going to clean up
our Funmi contract a little bit
to make it look a little bit
more professional. And I'm going
to talk about some of the syntax
and some of the reasons why some
conventions exist. We're not
going to do this full force on
all the projects moving forward.
But they are good to know and
they are good to keep in mind
when moving forward and working
with our contracts. While we go
through this we're going to
learn why some of these
conventions exist including
learning a little bit of low
level solidity. So don't skip
this part. When we get to later
sections. We're going to be a
little bit looser and not be as
strict with the code style
guides but That's basically what
we're gonna go over now. And for
now, you might see this event
funded thing here, please just
ignore that for now, in an
earlier take, I'd introduced the
events much earlier. And now
we're actually going to learn
about events a little bit later
in the course. So please ignore
that event funded for now. So
let's go ahead and tweak a
little bit of our contracts
here. Now what I'm talking about
tweaking this to make it look
professional, a little bit more
professional, I'm talking about
the solidity style guide, there
are some conventions for naming
and ordering that we can follow
to make our code look a little
bit better. Now, like I said,
this is going to be a little bit
more optional, because it can be
a little bit verbose. And it
doesn't really make that big of
a difference. But it can
increase readability of your
contracts by a lot and make your
code look a lot nicer. So if you
want, you can go through this
style guide to learn more about
what kind of makes solidity look
nice, and what makes it not look
nice. But well, that's some of
these style guides in here,
we're not going to follow the
style guide exactly to a tee.
But we are going to make some
best efforts to make our code
follow the style guide, we've
got a link to the style guide in
the GitHub repository for this
section, we can read some more
about the layout. But the main
thing we want to look at is this
order of the layout, we want to
start with our imports with our
pragma statement, our imports,
interfaces, libraries, and then
contracts. And then inside each
contract type declarations,
state variables, events,
modifiers, and functions. So
let's go back here and make sure
that we're up to speed, we want
our pragma first. Alright,
awesome, we did exactly that,
then we want our imports. Okay,
awesome, we have those too.
Something that's not in the
style guide is going to be error
codes, which we definitely want
next. So next is going to be
error codes. Now this is where
we're going to bump into one of
our first updates here. As of
recent, it's sort of becoming a
best practice to add the name of
your contract, some underscores,
and then the name of your error.
Whenever you're running into an
error. This makes it a lot
easier to understand which
contract is throwing the error.
So for this, we're going to say
error Funmi, two underscores not
owner, then we're going to
scroll down to the our revert
and set it like this. This way,
when if we ever run into this
error, we know that the error is
coming from the Funmi contract,
not from the aggregator v3
interface, or the price
converter or some other
contract. So that's how we want
to write our error codes here.
If we had any interfaces or
libraries not imported, we would
add them here. But then finally,
we add our contracts. In this
file, we only have one contract
here. It's our Funmi contract.
Awesome. Now the next thing we
want to learn about as far as
style guides go is this thing
called natspec. natspec stands
for Etherium natural language
specification format. And it's
basically a way of documenting
our code inspired by Doxygen
uses Doxygen style comments and
tags to help document our code,
you can click the link here in
the solidity documentation to
learn more about Doxygen. If we
scroll down in the
documentation, here, we can see
an example of using natspec.
Whenever we have a contract or a
function that needs
documentation, we can add some
syntax that looks like this to
it. So for example, if we wanted
to add this to our code, we
could add a comment explaining
this funding contract to start a
piece of natspec, you can do
three backslashes, or one
backslash, two stars, and then
another ending star here.
Everything we put inside of this
comment section basically gets
turned into a comment. For the
start of our contract, we'll do
the Add sign title to explain
basically, what this contract
is, it's fun, we contract is
going to be a contract
for crowdfunding, we'll add
another star. And we can add the
author of it, which is going to
be your name, I'm going to put
Patrick Collins, of course, then
we'll add a notice, which is
just kind of a note to people we
can say this contract is is to
demo a sample funding contract.
And we can also add apt Dev,
which is a note specifically to
developers. And we can say this
implements price feeds as our
library. The reason that we want
to add these tags here is
actually because we can use the
natspec to automatically create
documentation for us if we
download so we can actually run
solc dash s user doc dash dash
dev doc, and the name of our
file to automatically generate
documentation. So this is also
really helpful for automatically
creating documentation for other
developers who interact with the
protocol later on. You can use
this natspec For as many or as
few functions as you'd like.
Most of us probably aren't going
to be making documentation. So
we really just want to follow
those guidelines if we think
some function or some section of
our code is a little bit tricky
for other developers. Now that
we're inside of contract, we can
follow the order of our
contract. We're first going to
start with type declarations
which we don't really have any
except for the fact that we're
using our price converter for
the UN 256 type. Okay, great.
You Next, after our type
declarations, we're going to do
state variables. And in this
state variables section, this is
where we're actually going to
change the name of some of our
state variables. So we'll do a
little common here state
variables. Now in the solidity
style guide, kind of adhere to
the naming styles, we use upper
and lowercase, we use total caps
with underscores here. However,
these naming variables are going
to change in the future in this
section. And if you're following
along with the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
these are going to be actually a
little bit different than what
you see. However, for now, we're
going to leave them as they are,
because the reason why we're
going to change them isn't going
to be quite clear yet. Don't
worry. So these names are going
to change soon, but not yet.
Alright, after state variables
comes events, and modifiers. We
don't have any events, but we do
have a modifier. So we'll copy
this. And actually, we'll delete
this comment here. And we'll
paste our modifier here. Oh, and
it looks like looks like we're
not auto formatting here. So
we're going to uncomment
immutable actually, so that it
automatically auto formats.
Okay, great. We're out of
formatting now. And Cool.
Alright, so now we have our
modifiers. Next, we have right
here, and then we have all of
our functions. Great. We
actually want to group our
functions in this order that I
just print here. So we want the
constructor which we have
received and fall back, we do
have fall back and receive. So
we're going to actually copy
those and delete this comment.
We're gonna stick those veterans
Heath here looks like receive
goes first. So we'll put that
here. Then external functions,
then public, internal, private.
So we have public public. And
that's it. And then we can
delete this part down here.
Okay. Cool. And if we want, we
can do that syntax up here from
the net spec for our functions.
For example, for fund it, we
could even just copy paste, we
would remove title, we would
remove author, and we just say
add, notice, this function,
funds this contract. And we can
even leave a little dev thing
here to talk about it. Now if we
have parameters, you can do apt
puram. And say like what the
parameter is. And then if we
have returns, we can say
returns, or returns and then
what it returns for the
documentation. Since this
doesn't have any parameters in
here, and doesn't return
anything, we can just leave it
like this. And great, we've just
revamped our contract here to
make it a little bit more nicely
formatted. Great job. Now, like
I said, we actually are going to
change the names of our state
variables, and we're going to
add some functions in here and a
little bit. So if we're
following with the GitHub repo,
the state of the contract right
now is going to look a little
bit different. But it'll make
sense why change this up in a
little bit.
Alright, so now that we've
cleaned this up, we've got to
deploy marks, deploy Funmi.
Let's go ahead and start writing
some tests. And after we write
these tests, we're actually
going to run that gas estimator
and using that gas estimator,
we're gonna go back, and we're
going to update this contract
one more time to make this even
cheaper to use and work with.
And remember, that's going to be
one of the advantages of writing
these tests is how we can
optimize our contracts to be
even faster, more gas efficient,
etc, we want to make sure that
we write really good tests, and
this is going to be one of our
first jumps into these more
professional test setups. So
we're going to jump into our
test folder, we're going to
delete this sample test.js. In
our last section, we went over a
really minimalistic test, which
is great. However, when we get
bigger and bigger projects,
we're going to want to start
testing more and more different
things, we're going to get more
and more into at least two
different types of testing. So
if we cd into our test folder,
we're going to make one
directory called staging. And
then we're going to make another
directory called unit. And now
if we look in our test folder,
we now have a staging folder,
and a unit test folder. Now
we're going to talk about two
different types of tests. The
first one is going to be
something called a unit test.
Now what is a unit test? Unit
testing is a software testing
method by which individual units
of source code are tested.
Basically, what we want to do is
in our contracts, we want to
test minimal portions of our
code to make sure that they work
correctly. Then once our small
pieces of the test work, we want
to do a staging test or maybe an
integration test. This might be
where we run our code on a test
net or some actual network. You
can think of a staging test,
it's kind of the last stop
before you deploy to a main net.
They're not always 100%
necessary, but they can be
really, really helpful.
Remember, we do want to be
conscientious of how much we use
our test nets, but we absolutely
would 100% want to make sure
that everything works locally
and that we unit test and we run
all of our code locally. Then we
can use staging tests on an
actual test net to make sure
that our code will work with
actual other contracts. Now unit
tests can be done with local
Hard Hat Network or a forked
Hard Hat Network, we'll talk
about this for tar Hat Network
very soon, right, now, let's
build these unit tests, these
unit tests are going to be
basically what we saw in our
last section. So let's go in and
let's jump in and write some of
these unit tests. So let's
create a new test, we'll call it
on me dot test dot j, s. And
we'll start making our tests in
here. Now, we did test
previously in our last section,
but our tests here are going to
look a little bit differently,
we're actually going to use
hardhat deploy, to automatically
set up our tests as if both of
these deployed functions had
been run. So let's go ahead and
get this started. So we're still
going to do that same setup that
we're gonna do describe, we're
gonna say fund me. And this is
going to have that async
function like so. And in here,
we're going to have a before
each, and we're going to have
some hits and some describes and
everything. Now since we want to
unit test this, we're gonna go a
little bit heavier on the test
here, and then with our last
project, but in the future,
we'll go a little bit lighter
with some of the tests. So let's
get started. If we run yarn
Hardhead test right now, we're
gonna get zero passing. Now, if
we run yarn hardhat coverage,
we're gonna get something that
looks like this, saying, Hey,
you're missing a lot of stuff.
So let's try to cover some more
lines with our tests. And one
way we can do that is actually
we can group our tests based off
of different functions. So let's
have our first set of tests be
around our constructor. To do
that inside of our first
describe, we can add another
describe, have this describe the
just the constructor, this
larger scope will be for the
entire Funmi contract. And
everything inside this one will
just be for the constructor. So
this will also be an async
function. And these tasks will
be just for the constructor. But
before we even work on this
describe, we probably want to
deploy our Funmi contract. So
let's learn how to do that. So
we'll do a before each, which
will be an async function. And
we're going to deploy our Funmi
contract using hard hat deploy.
Since we use hard hat deploy,
our Funmi contract will come
even with our mocks and
everything. So above the before
each,
let's do let me HDMI. And then
here, we're going to deploy
Funmi, where we're going to
deploy our Funmi contract is
first by pulling in our
deployments object from Harnett
deploy. So we'll do const
deployments equals require
hardhat. And this deployments
object has, has a function
called fixture with fixture does
is it allows us to basically run
our entire deploy folder with as
many tags as we want. You'll
notice I added this alt tag in
both of our scripts. This means
that in this deployment stuff
fixtures, it's gonna be a wait
deployment of fixtures. If I run
away deployments dot fixture,
I'll run through our deploy
scripts on our local network and
deploy all of the contracts that
we can use them in our scripts
and in our testing, and we can
deploy everything in that deploy
folder with just this one line.
isn't that helpful. Now, once
all of our contracts have been
deployed, we can start getting
them will say fund me equals
await ethers, and we'll pull an
ether some hard hat as well. dot
and this is where hard hat
deploy is helpful. Again, hard
to deploy rapt ether is with a
function called Get contract,
this get contract function is
going to get the most recent
deployment of whatever contract
we tell it. So we'll say get
contract of fun to me. So this
will give us the most recent Lee
deployed Funmi contract in just
this one line. And now Funmi
will be equal to this line here.
Now we're going to make a bunch
of transactions on our Funmi. To
test it. Of course, we can also
tell ethers which account we
want connected to fund me. So I
can say const deployer equals
goes away get named accounts,
exactly like we did in our
deploy scripts. And then we just
need to import it from our tap
in our deploy scripts we
imported get named accounts
inside of our input parameters
for our deploy function.
Remember getting named accounts
and deployments was abstracted
from if we look up here, from
the hard hat runtime
environment, and like I said,
the hard hat runtime environment
is basically the same thing as
hard hat. So we can just go
ahead and import it like this,
actually like this. Because we
actually need to abstract just
the deployer from getting named
accounts. And now what we can do
is we can connect our Deployer
to our Fund Me account. So
whenever we call a function with
fund me, it'll automatically be
from that the player account,
which is great. Another way you
can get different accounts
directly from your heart had
config. Is you could take const
accounts equals await ethers dot
get signers, ethers dot get
signers is going to return
whatever is in this account
section of your network. If
you're on your default network
hard hat, it's going to give you
a list of 10 fake accounts that
we can work with you then of
course, can do something like
const. Account one equals
accounts. More correctly would
be account zero equals account
zero and work like that. We'll
leave that comment that out,
just in case you need a
reference to it in the future.
Okay, great. So now we have our
Funmi contract. Let's go ahead
and write some tests for testing
the constructor. And we're
probably going to want to use
this deployer object down here.
So we'll do let deployer above.
And we'll do something a little
finicky here. But we'll say
deployer equals Wait, get named
accounts, dot Deployer. And
we'll just wrap this up so that
we can just grab this deployer
object and assign it to declare
like so. Now in here, we'll
create our first test, we'll say
it will say it sets the Agra
Gator addresses correctly. Comma
will have this be an async
function. And we'll say const
response equals await fund me
dot, let's get this price feed
here, fund me dot price feed.
And then we'll want to make sure
this price feed is going to be
the same as our Mk V three
aggregator since we're going to
be running these tests locally.
So we should get our mark three
V three aggregator up top. Let's
do let mock v3 aggregate store.
And we'll grab this address the
same way mockbee Three
aggregator equals await ethers
dot get contract mockbee Three
aggregator comma, we'll connect
this one to the deployer as
well. So we'll want to say cert
dot equals cert dot equal
response comma lock v3
aggregator dot address. And of
course we'll want to say const.
Assert equals require gy. Import
that from DJI. Okay, cool.
Now, let's go ahead and try this
out. Yarn hardhat. Test. Oops, I
spelled response wrong. Let's
try that again. Awesome. So this
means that we are indeed
assigning the price feed address
correctly to the Mach v3
aggregator. Okay, great.
Awesome. I think for now, that's
all we really want to do for our
constructor. Now these two are
kind of a nice to have, I showed
them more just to kind of demo
what they look like, we're going
to skip writing tests for them
for now. And we're actually
going to go ahead and delete
them directly from the contract.
If you want to go ahead and
write some tests for them and
leave them in your examples for
your learnings. You absolutely
can pause the video and write
some tests for it if you choose
so, but we're going to skip
them. Next though, we are going
to move on to fund and running
some tests for fun here. So
let's go ahead and write
describe fund. This will be an
async function. And in here,
we're going to do a number of
tests. So if we're going to go
line by line here, what's the
first thing that we should look
at? Well, we should look at this
require line we should write a
test to see if this contract
actually does fail? If not
enough, eath is sent. So let's
go ahead and we'll say it fails,
if you don't send enough eath
have this be an async function?
Now, how do we test to see if
something fails? Right now we've
done assert equals, but if
something fails, we might run
into an issue. So for example,
if I run await fund me dot fund,
but I don't pass any value to
this transaction. Let's see what
happens. I run yarn Hardhead
test. Well, our test is actually
going to break VM exception.
While processing transaction
reverted with reason string, you
need to spend more eath. So our
tests are going to break which
is good. We want this to break.
But we want to tell our test
that this is okay. Right? Want
to tell that this is okay. So
the way we can do this, and this
is where our waffle testing
comes into play. With waffle and
with testing, what we can
actually do is we can use the
expect keyword and expect
transactions to be reverted and
for transactions to fail. So
instead of using assert here,
we're actually going to run a
wait expect fund me dot fun 2.2
dot B, that reverted and we've
actually even be more specific
here by saying to be reverted
with and then the exact reverted
error, you need to spend more
eath. Now if we run our tests,
oops expect is not defined. So
we need to import that from
Chai. Which chai is being
overwritten by waffle, we see
that it does indeed Pass, which
is perfect. So now we have a way
to both assert things and expect
things to fail. Awesome, even
with the specific failure codes.
Perfect. Let's write some more
tests here. Well, we probably
want it to correctly update this
data structure. So we could say,
it updates the amount funded
data structure, it's going to be
an async function. In here,
we're going to need to call fund
v dot fund. However, we're going
to need to actually pass some
value with this transaction. And
for now, we'll just hard code
the value that we're going to
send, say const. Send value is
going to be
112345 678-910-1234 5678, which
is going to be one eath. Another
way we can write this though, is
we can use the ethers utility to
make this a little bit easier to
read. Because all those zeros
are kind of confusing, and it's
hard to tell at first glance
what this actually is. So we're
gonna actually use ethers dot
utils dot parse ether, one, this
parse ethers utility converts
this one into that one with 18
zeros, which makes life a lot
easier. If you go to the ethers
documentation, there's also a
parts units function where you
can actually convert any unit,
either ethers or Gwei. Or really
whatever you want to do, you
could convert any number to any
other Aetherium you type. So
this is the set value that we're
going to use for our fund. And,
and this is definitely going to
be more than our minimum USD of
50. So after we call this fun
function, we'll say const
response is going to be equal to
a weight, fund me dot address to
Mt funded address to Mt funded
for the deployer dot address.
Because remember, this is a
mapping of each address and how
much they've actually funded. So
if we use the deployer address,
it should give us the amount
that we actually sent. So now we
can run assert dot equal
response.to string, right,
because this response is going
to be the big number version of
how much has been funded by that
account. And that should be the
same as our send value.to
string. Since send value, our
one should be the exact same as
the amount that we funded, we
can run just this one test, or
running yarn, art hat, test,
dash dash grep. And we'll put
this in quotes allow funded for
this amount funded line. And it
looks like we ran into an issue
here, because we don't need to
do deployed at address, we can
just do deploy here. And great,
it looks like we are indeed
passing. Now if we even run yarn
Hardhead coverage will now see
we've got at least a little bit
more coverage here. It's still
not going to be great. But we
have much better coverage. We
have some statements, some
branches, and at least some
functions covered. So this is
awesome. Let's keep going. Are
we all done testing our fun
function? Well, probably not.
What else can we do with our fun
function? Well, we're also
adding funders to a funders
array. So let's go ahead and
test for that. So it adds funder
to array of funders has been an
async function. And we'll say
await fund mean that fund value
is going to be send value. We'll
say const response equals await
fund me dot calling the funders
array at index zero. So this
will be funder equals await fund
me dot funders zero. And then
we'll say assert dot equal
funder should be the same as the
Deployer. So let's go ahead and
run this test. We'll hit up a
couple times. And we'll change
the GREP to under to array so
that it looks for this line. And
perfect. It looks like that one
is also passing. Great. So the
money's coming through, the
minimum amount is coming through
and our data structures are
being updated. Awesome. Now we
could be a little bit more
verbose and do even more testing
with this fun function. But I
think for the most part, we've
got the gist, right. So now
let's go ahead and move on to
the withdrawal function. So
we're going to create a new
describe or withdraw. This is
going to be an async function.
And let's see what the
withdrawal function does. Only
the owner of the contract is
going to be able to get the
balance, get the money back. And
we're also going to reset all of
the amounts that each one of
these users is done. So let's go
ahead and do some withdrawing.
Now in order for us to test
withdraw, we probably first want
the contract to actually have
some money and so what we can do
actually is we can add another
before each in the describe to
automatically fund the contract
before we run any tests. So we
can say before each async
function. We can say await, fund
me dot fund. Value, send value.
Now for all of our tests in this
withdrawal scope, we're first
going to fund it with eath.
Let's say it can withdraw,
withdraw eath. From a single
founder, this would be an async
function. And this is going to
be a little bit longer test. So
I'm going to set it up to be an
arrange, act and assert test. So
arrange act assert is just sort
of a way to think about writing
tests, you want to arrange the
test, then you want to act. And
then you want to run the
asserts, and you'll see what I
mean in just a second. So we're
going to arrange this test,
we're going to set this test up,
we want to actually check that
we're correctly withdrawing the
ether from a single founder. So
first, we're going to get the
starting balance of the
fundraising contract and the
Deployer. So we'll say const.
Starting under me, balance,
equals await, fund me dot
provider, dot get balance, fund
me dot address. So we're gonna
start with the balance of the
fund V contract after it's been
funded with some eath. And we're
also gonna get costs start
starting, deploy your balance
goes await, fund me dot
provider, dot get balance of
deployed employer.
So we're getting the starting
balance of the Funmi, we're
getting to the starting balance
of the employer so that we can
test later on how much these
numbers have changed based off
of what happens when we call the
withdrawal function. Now that
we've done a little bit of
setup, we can actually run this
withdrawal function, we can do
the act here. So we're gonna say
const, trans action response
equals await, fund me dot
withdraw. And then we can say
const, transaction receipt
equals await transaction
response. That Wait, one, and
now we should be able to check
to see that the entire fund
rebalance has been added to the
deployer balance. So now we can
say const ending fund me balance
equals a weight on me that
provider dot get balance of
Unreal dot address. Then we can
say const ending deployer
balance equals await, fund me
dot provider dot get balance
of Deployer. And now we can just
check to see if the numbers work
out here.
So we can say assert dot equal
ending fund me balance is going
to be zero, right, because we
just withdrew all of the money.
So ending funding balance should
be zero. And we'll say assert
dot equal starting fund me
balance plus starting deployer
balance. So the starting funds
the balance plus the starting
employer balance should equal
the ending employer balance.
Since we're grabbing whatever
the starting deployer balance
started with plus the starting
fund to be balanced, because we
just withdrew all of the
starting fund, we balance that
should equal the ending deployer
bots. Now a couple of notes
here, since starting Funmi
balance is calling from the
blockchain, it's going to be of
type a big number, we want to
use big number dot add actually,
instead of the plus sign here,
just because it'll it'll make
working with our big numbers a
little bit easier. So instead of
starting Funmi balance, plus
we're gonna be starting from the
balance dot add. Like that. And
that should be good. One other
thing about this, though, is
that when we called withdraw our
Deployer did what our Deployer
spent a little bit of gas. So
this actually isn't accurate. We
actually also need to calculate
in the gas cost, so we wouldn't
need to do dot add gas cost.
We'd also have to do.to string
because big numbers are objects
and so identities a little bit
weird. So to test to see if
they're equal, we'll just make
them both strings. Now we don't
have gas costs. So let's figure
out how to get the gas cost from
this transaction. So we can add
it to Are any deployer bounce,
so we can run this assertion
here. So what we can do is we
can actually find the gas costs
from our transaction receipt.
And I'm going to show you a
couple of phenomenal tricks you
can use with VS code. And if
using a different editor, then
don't worry too much about this.
What we can do in VS code
actually is create something
called breakpoints. unverified
breakpoint file is modified to
please restart the bug session,
or let's put it right here, put
it right in this line after
transaction receipt is created.
But before ending Funmi belts,
what this breakpoint does is it
stops the script at this line,
and allows us to drop into
something called a debug console
and see all the variables that
are happening. At this time, we
want to look at the transaction
receipt and see if the total gas
cost is in there. This is also
incredibly helpful for dropping
into tests and dropping into
scripts and seeing exactly
what's going on that's wrong. So
what we can do is we can move
down to this run into bug
section. And if it's not there,
you can hit additional views.
And we can click this JavaScript
Debug Terminal, which will
create a new terminal in our
terminal section. Now, what
happens here is if we run yarn,
hard hat test, it'll run our
testing and everything. But when
it hits this breakpoint, it'll
stop. Currently, there is no gas
cost. So we're just going to
delete this for now. So that we
compile and we work in
everything. But if we run yarn
Hardhead test, see, it's gonna
say debugger has been attached
to start running our tests. And
it's going to stop on this line
here. And if we look in this
variable section on the left
hand side, we can actually see a
ton of the variables that are in
here. And we can read a little
bit more about what's going on.
And if we go over to our debug
console, we can type in things
like transaction receipt, and we
can see a ton of information
about that transaction receipt
object, what we're looking for
is we're looking to see this
transaction receipt, which we
could look in the debug console
or over here, if there's
anything to do with gas in here.
And it looks like there is
there's a gas used big number.
And there's also an effective
gas price. So the amount of gas
used times the gas price is
going to give us all the money
that we paid for gas here. So
now that we've figured out
there's a gas used and effective
gas price variables in this
transaction receipt, which we
could have also found in the
documentation here. However,
sometimes it's even quicker just
to find it out yourself what we
can do, we can exit the debugger
by clicking this little thing
here. Go back to terminal will
trash can the JavaScript
debugger, we'll remove the
breakpoint. And we'll grab those
two variables we can pull them
right out of that transaction
receipt object by typing const.
Yes, used comma effective gas
price equals transaction
receipt. So again, with this
curly bracket syntax, we can use
this to pull out objects out of
another object. And now that we
have these two objects, we can
create a const gas cost or total
gas cost is going to be equal to
the gas used times the effective
gas price. Which again, since
these are both big numbers, we
can use a big number function
called dot mol to multiply them
together. Now that we have this
total gas cost, we can come down
and we can say the ending
deployer balance plus that gas
cost to string. Now the two of
these should be equivalent. I
know there's a lot of math that
we're doing in this section and
a lot of new things. So I want
to just quickly rego over what
we just learned. So first off,
the font of the contract comes
with a provider, we could have
also done ethers dot provider
dot get balance, but we're using
fun v dot provider because we're
using the provider of the Funmi
contract. It doesn't really
matter what we use here. We just
wanted to use this get balanced
function of the provider object
which gets us the balance of any
contract. We do the same thing
with starting deplore balance.
The reason that we needed the
starting balances is because we
wanted to compare it to the
ending balances to see if all
the money went to the right
places, we then call the
withdrawal function. And from
the transaction receipt, we
grabbed the gas used and the gas
price. If you want to debug your
JavaScript code, you can add a
breakpoint like so go to run
into bug, open your debug
JavaScript terminal, which is
different from your regular bash
terminals. And when you run
JavaScript commands in here,
they will stop where your
breakpoints are. Then you can
read the different variables and
see where different things are.
Using that knowledge. We pulled
out the gas use and effective
gas price from the transaction
receipt and used it to get the
total gas cost of this
transaction, we then got the
ending fund, we balanced the
ending deployer balance, and
used all those variables to make
sure all the money went to the
right places. And we, we can
check this by running yarn
Hardhead test dash dash grep
withdraw eath in quotes, since
there's a space here, and we can
see that our test does indeed
pass. Great job. If we didn't
add the gas cost here, and we
just did.to string, we would see
something like this, we would
see that the numbers are ever so
slightly off, because we're not
anticipating we're not
calculating the gas here. So we
always want to make sure we're
using the gas if we're doing
calculations like this. Now
another incredibly powerful
debugging tool that we're not
really going to go over here.
But it's important to know about
because it can be really helpful
is that you can actually use
console dot log in your solidity
with hard hat. If you're inside
of a heart hat project, you just
import hard hat slash console
dot soul. And then right in your
solidity, you can do console dot
log, and then type pretty much
whatever you want. When you
execute these functions, similar
to how we do a console dot log
in JavaScript, those will
actually console dot log out to
your terminal. Here's an example
of if you run yarn, hard hat
test and you have those console
dot logs, you'll see stuff like
this get printed out. So in
addition to the Visual Studio
Code debugger, importing hard
hat slash console dot Sol, and
using console dot logs in your
solidity can also be an
effective debugging strategy.
Feel free to give this video a
pause, implement this in some of
our contracts and try it out in
our tests. So we tested that
withdrawing eath when there's a
single funder works perfectly,
let's test withdrawing eath if
there are multiple funders, so
we'll do it, let's say allows us
to withdraw with multiple
funders. Why would this be an
async function. And let's do
this await Funmi not fun, but
with a number of different
accounts. So we can create a
whole bunch of different
accounts of course, by saying
const accounts equals await
ethers dot get signers. And we
can loop through these accounts
and have each one of these
accounts call the fund function.
And we're going to do this with
a for loop. So we're going to
say for let i equals we'll start
with the first index of the
accounts because the zero with
index is going to be the
Deployer. So we'll say let i
equals one is going to be less
than let's say six. And we'll do
i plus plus. And in here, we'll
say const. And me contract Funmi
connected contract equals await.
And me dot connect two accounts,
I, so we need to call this
connect function because right
now if we scroll up back to the
top, our Funmi contract is
connected to our Deployer
account. And anytime we call a
transaction with Funmi, the
deployer is the account that is
calling that transaction, we
need to create new objects to
connect to all of these
different accounts. So we're
gonna say fund me connected
contract, which is now connected
to one of these different
accounts dot fund. And this is
where we'll do value, send
value. Or excuse me, we'll do
await. Great. So this is going
to be our our range section. And
then same as we did above, we
need to grab those starting
balances. So we can just copy
that, those two lines and paste
that down here. Now we're going
to move into act, I'm going to
call that withdrawal function
again. So let's say const,
transaction action response
equals await and MI dot
withdraw. And we're going to do
the exact same thing as we did
above, getting the transaction
receipt and the gas costs so we
can get everything correct. Once
we've done the act, we move on
into assert. And we're going to
do some very similar things to
what we did above, like this,
for example, this whole first
part is going to be exactly the
same. We also want to make sure
the funders are reset properly.
So we'll make sure that this
funders array is reset properly.
So to do that, we can actually
just check to see that if
looking at the zero with
position throws an error so we
can run a wait expect fund me
dot get on me dot funder on me
dot funders of zero. This should
revert so we'll say await expect
Funmi dot funders dot two dot b
dot reverted and then we want to
loop through all these accounts
and make sure that it makes sure
or that in our mapping here, all
their amounts are zero. So we'll
say, for I equals one is less
than six,
i plus plus, we'll say assert
dot equal. Wait, fund me dot
address to amount funded, of the
accounts of I got address should
be zero. So we're making sure
that all of these mappings are
correctly updated to zero. So
let's go and test this. So we're
withdrawing with multiple
founders, we're going to go back
to our terminal, we're going to
hit up, we're going to change
this GREP or this one. We'll see
if this passes. And it does
indeed, so this means that our
withdraw function works really
well even when there's multiple
funders and we can be happy and
go to sleep knowing that. Now
the other thing we absolutely
want 100% want to test is that
our only owner modifier is
working, we want only the owner
to be able to withdraw the funds
from here. So we'll create a new
session, we'll say it only
allows the owner to withdraw
only allows you to withdraw.
This will be an async function.
And in here, we'll say const.
Accounts equals ethers dot get
signers again. And we'll say
const attacker equals accounts
of one. So we'll say the first
account will be some random
attacker will connect this
attacker to a new contract,
we'll say const attacker
connected contract equals await
on DB dot Connect. Attacker dot
address, excuse me a dot connect
attacker. Since we're not just
connecting the address, we're
connecting the account which
attacker is an account object.
And then we'll do a wait expect
attacker connected contract dot
withdraw dot two dot b dot
reverted, they should not be
able to withdraw. So let's go
ahead, we can even just copy
this whole thing if we want to
hit up, we'll delete this
section here. We'll paste that
in. And boom. This means that
when some other account tries to
call withdraw, automatically
gets reverted, which is what we
want. Now we can be more
explicit to make sure that the
correct error code is being
thrown, not just that it's
reverted. Right, it can be very
reverted because they sent ether
did it they did something weird,
we want to make sure it's
reverted with our specific error
code. So right now we have this
not owner error code. But it's
actually a best practice to put
the contract name to underscores
and then your custom error. This
makes it a lot easier in the
future when you have a ton of
different contracts, and you're
not sure where an error is
coming from. So we're going to
just update this really quickly
to be fund me underscore
underscore, not owner, now we
can do is now that we have this
custom error, we can say
withdraw that to be reverted
with, then we can add our custom
error in here. Now, if we rerun
our test, with only allows the
owner to withdraw, oops, we need
to do a wait here. My mistake,
wait a Thursday, get signers.
And now let's try this again.
And we are indeed passing
Perfect.
Okay, great. We have some basic
unit tests here. And we're going
to write some staging tests
pretty soon. But before we
actually do that, let's go ahead
and add the gas estimator. And
we'll see how much gas these
contracts in these functions are
taking. It looks like the
Hardhead gas reporter is already
here. So let's scroll down.
We'll do gas reporter true. And
we won't do coin market cap
here. And we'll just look purely
at the GUI. So you can just
comment it out like that. Now
rerun all of our tests. So we'll
say yarn, our test. And in doing
so we're gonna get that that gas
output in that gas report dash
text here. So looks like all of
our tests are passing, which is
perfect. Now we can look into
our gas report and see what's
going on here. i Well, it looks
like the fundraising function is
taking a decent chunk of gas,
the withdrawal function, take it
some guests to we'd see the min,
the max and the average. Of
course, we can see how much each
one of these contracts cost to
actually output. We don't really
care about the MOQ aggregator of
course, because we're never
actually going to use that.
Let's say we look at the average
gas for these and we go hmm,
this looks like it's actually a
lot more than what we originally
expected. Is there a way for us
to make this a little bit cheap.
If we go back to our funding
contract, we look at our
withdrawal function. And we
noticed something, oh, there is
actually a way to make this a
lot cheaper. And it has to do
with something called storage
variables, or these global
variables that we've been
working with this whole time.
Let me let me paint you a little
picture here, we're gonna look
at one of the first gas
optimization techniques you can
take to drop these down. And it
has to do with an R Funmi.
Contract these state variables
and how they're actually stored
and how this contract actually
keeps track of all this stuff,
this section is going to be a
little bit more advanced. So
we'll have a note here saying
that this is an advanced
section, if you want to skip
over it, you can, because now
we're getting into gas
optimizations here, this
information still is really good
to know. So if you want to skip
it for now, and then come back
later, you absolutely can. But
let's talk about what happens
when we actually save or store
these global variables. Okay,
these storage variables. Now,
everything I'm about to go
through is in the documentation.
And there is a link to this, of
course, in the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
whenever we have one of these
global variables, or these
variables that stay permanently,
they're stuck in something
called storage, you can think of
storage as a big giant array, or
a giant list of all the
variables that we actually
create. So when we say we have
some contract called Son of
storage, and we have a variable
called favorite number, we're
basically saying we want this
favorite number variable to
persist, right, we saw in a lot
of our examples, we had a
favorite number variable that we
can always call to see what this
contracts favorite number was,
well, the way it persists, is it
gets stored in this place called
storage. A storage box is this
giant list associated with this
contract where every single
variable and every single value
in the storage section is
slotted into a 32 byte long slot
in this storage array. So for
example, the number 25 in its
bytes implementation is 000 with
a ton of zeros 19. This is the
hex version of the yuan 256.
This is why we do so much hex
translation, the bytes
implementation of a yuan 256.
And each store saw increments
just like an array starting from
zero. So for example, our next
global variable or next storage
variable just gets slotted at
the next slot that's available.
So bullions, for example, get
transformed from their bull
version two, their hex and we
modified our some bool variable
to be true and X edition of the
true Boolean 0x 001. Every time
you save an additional global
variable, or more correctly, one
of these storage variables, it
takes up an additional storage
slot. And what about variables
that are dynamic in length, or
that can change length? What
about something that's dynamic?
Well, for dynamic values, like a
dynamic array, or a mapping
elements inside the array or
inside the mapping are actually
stored using some type of
hashing function. And you can
see those specific functions in
the documentation, the object
itself does take up a storage
slot, but it's not going to be
the entire array. For example,
my array variable here at
storage, slot two doesn't have
the entire array in storage slot
two, what has actually is just
the array length, the length of
the array is stored at storage
slot two. But for example, if we
do my array dot push 222, we do
some hashing function, which
again, you can see in the
documentation what that is, and
we'll store the number 222. At
that location in storage, the
hex of 222 is 0x 0000 D, so it
gets stored in this crazy spot.
And this is good, this is
intentional, because 32 Bytes
may not be nearly big enough to
store my array if our array gets
massive. And it wouldn't make
sense for to put the elements
inside the array at subsequent
numbers because again, the size
of the array can change and
you're never going to be sure
how many subsequence that you
need. So for my array, it does
have a storage slot for the
length for mappings. It does
have a storage spot as well
similar to array, but it's just
blank. But it's blank
intentionally so that solidity
knows, okay, there is a mapping
here, and it needs a storage
slot for attaching functional
work correctly. Now
interestingly, constant
variables and immutable
variables do not take up spots
in storage. The reason for this
is because constant variables
are actually part of the
contracts byte code itself,
which sounds a little bit weird.
But you can imagine what
solidity does is anytime it sees
constant variables name is it
just automatically swaps it out
with whatever number it actually
is. So you can kind of think of
not in storage is just a pointer
to 123 and it doesn't take up a
storage slot. Well when we have
variables inside of a function,
those variables only exist for
the duration of the function.
They don't stay inside the
contract. They don't persist
they're not permanent. So
variables inside these functions
like new var and other var do
not get added to storage. They
get added in their own memory
data structure. Which gets
deleted after the function has
finished running. Now you might
be asking, Okay, well, why do we
need this memory keyword,
especially when it comes to
strings, we saw before that we
had to say String memory. The
reason we need it for strings is
because strings are technically
this dynamically sized array.
And we need to tell solidity,
hey, we're going to do this on
the storage location, or we're
going to do it into the memory
location where we can just wipe
it. arrays and mappings can take
up a lot more space. So slowly,
just wants to make sure Okay,
where are we working with this
is it storage is a memory, you
have to tell me, I need to know
if I need to allocate space for
it in our storage data
structure. And again, everything
here you can read in the
solidity documentation. Now, in
the GitHub repo associated with
this course, if you go to
contracts, we've actually got an
example contract section called
Fun with storage, where you can
play with and look at a lot of
this stuff. And we even wrote a
little script called deploy
storage fun, where it'll print
out the storage location of some
of the different variables, feel
free to give it a run, if you
want to try a challenge anybody
to write some functions that
find the storage slots of the
elements of the arrays, and the
mappings, and then find the data
inside of those as well. We use
a function here called Get
storage app, which allows us to
get the storage at any one of
these slots. And this is to
reinforce that even if you have
a function as private or
internal. Anybody can still read
it. Anybody can read anything
off the blockchain. And you can
test it exactly what this if you
go ahead and get clone that or
copy paste the code yourself.
You can then run yarn part at
deploy dash test tags, storage.
And you'll run the deploy script
for that storage.
And you'll see printing out the
location of storage in each
storage slot with a fun contract
that we made as an example. And
you might of course be asking,
Okay, Patrick, why are you
telling me all this? We're just
trying to get this gas price
down? Why are you telling me all
about this storage thing? Well,
the reason I'm telling you all
about the storage thing. Anytime
you read or you write to and
from storage, you spend a ton of
gas. Remember I said when we
compile our code, we compile it
down to some crazy weird
bytecode. Well, let me show you
on remix what this looks like.
We go to compliation details, we
can go to bytecode. And we see
this weird hex object zero,
blah, blah, blah. But we also
see these things called op
codes. Now, this bytecode here
represents these op codes. Each
one of these op codes represents
a small piece of everything in
this bytecode. And in fact, in
our heart hat, we can go to
artifacts, build info, and we
can see, we can see these op
codes in the build info, we can
do a command F or Control F for
opcodes. We can see op codes for
different contracts. These op
codes represent what the machine
code is doing. And they
represent how much computational
work it takes to actually run
our code and do stuff with our
code. The way that gas is
actually calculated is by these
opcodes. There are a couple of
lists here. But here's one that
I'm going to use this EVM
opcodes. And again, there's a
link to this in the GitHub repo
associated with this lesson.
Well, if we scroll down, we can
see exactly how much it costs
for each one of these op codes.
So for example, anytime we add,
it costs three gas, anytime we
multiply, that's five gas,
subtracting three gas, we have
all of these op codes that cost
different amounts of gas in in
our functions, here's kind of a
sample contract. If we're doing
adding, anytime we add it's
going to cost three gas. Anytime
we save to memory, it's going to
cost gas from some other
opcodes. These op codes combined
show us how much gas we actually
use. Now, let's look at a lot of
these op codes and how much they
cost three 510, three, three,
balance is 700. So getting the
balance is is a ton of gas.
Let's keep going. Getting the
sides of an Accounts code is a
lot of gas copying and accounts
code into memory. But oh my
goodness, what is this save word
to storage costs a ton of gas
that is 20,000 gas and s load
load word from storage cost 800
gas. These are two of the most
important opcodes s load and s
store which stands for storage
load and storage store. Anytime
one of these op codes fires,
we're spending 800 or 20,000.
You know, there's a big asterisk
there because that can change a
lot. But we're spending a ton of
gas anytime we work with storage
as developers. Anytime we work
with some stuff in storage, we
want to go boy, this is about to
cost me a lot of gas and the
best convention or making sure
we know that we're working with
a stored variable and we're
about to spend a lot of gas is
to append an S underscore right
before them which stands for
storage right So we're saying
address to amount funded is
going to be a storage variable
wonders is going to be a storage
variable. Owner is not going to
be a storage variable. It's
immutable. The best practice for
immutable variables is
prefixing. It with an I
underscore constant values are
also not in storage. So for
constant values, we want to keep
them capslock, like that
aggregator v3 interface public
price feed. Yep, you know what
that is going to be a storage
variable. So we want to append
an S underscore with it. So
we're going to do a little bit
more refactor, we've appended
these appropriately to update
everything. So instead of owner,
it's going to be I underscore
owner, and as a developer will
read this, and we'll go ah, this
is going to be much cheaper than
a regular variable. Okay, that's
great. I'm going to work with
this. This I underscore owner
for my modifier. Awesome. Is
owner anywhere else in here?
Okay, right in the constructor.
I own underscore owner is
message dot sender. Price feed
is a storage variable. We should
as developers, we should see the
s underscore when reading this
and go, Okay, we're spending a
lot of gas to store this.
Perfect. Okay, great. Let's keep
going. Great. We've updated all
the owners. Okay, well, what
about address to amount funded?
In VS code? If you do Command F,
or Ctrl, F, and you hit this
little down arrow, you can
actually find and replace all of
these address to amount funded
with s underscore address to Mt
funded. Hit it like that. And
since I updated one, I got a
backspace that one no. So now
these are all updated. Let's do
the same thing with s funders.
Let's update everywhere. It has
funders just to be s funders.
And we probably doubled up here.
Yep.
Let's undo that. We already
updated all the AI owners. So
now it's updated all the price
feeds. So let's look for price
feed, we'll update it with ES
price feed. And then we probably
doubled up right here. So we'll
undo that. Okay, great. Now that
we've updated everything in
here, we can scroll down and we
can oops, sorry, doubled up
there too. Sorry. We can we can
green through our code and go
okay, where are we reading and
writing to storage way more
often than we probably need to.
And that's when we get to this
withdrawal function, which seems
rather suspect to reading and
writing to storage a lot. So
let's take a look at what we're
doing here. Okay, so first of
all, I can see that we're doing
a for loop here. And every time
we do a for loop, we're just
constantly looping through all
of this code. Every single time
we're doing a little compare
option here we're saying, okay,
is our funder index less than s
funders dot length? S funders
dot length, this means the
longer our funders array is, the
more times we're going to be
reading from storage, that's
incredibly expensive. We're also
recalling this, oh my goodness,
we're reading from storage a lot
and saving it to this memory
variable, and then updating our
storage variable with it. Wow.
So we're reading from storage a
ton here, and we're reading from
storage a ton here, okay, then
we have to reset our funders
array, there's really no way
around it. And that's pretty
much it for our reading and
writing to storage, we could
probably create a withdrawal
function, that's a lot cheaper.
So let's go ahead and create a
function called cheaper
withdraw, function, cheaper
withdraw. That's going to take
what we've just learned and make
a cheaper withdraw, that's much
more gas efficient. So we'll
keep this public payable. and
have it be only owner, we're not
going to change anything there.
But what can we do for at least
this part here, we don't want to
keep reading from storage here.
And we don't want to always have
to keep reading from storage
here. We're like doubling up the
amount of storage we're reading
from. So instead, what we can
do, we can read this entire
array into memory one time, and
then read from memory instead of
constantly reading from storage.
And that's going to make our
lives a lot cheaper. So we can
create an address array. Memory
funders equals s underscore,
funders. And now it's going to
start making sense why for
arrays and strings in our
functions, it makes us say, hey,
is this memory is a storage?
What is this? And we're telling
it, we want it to be memory
because memory is going to be a
lot cheaper. So now that we're
saving it into our funders, oh,
and a quick note mappings can't
be in memory. Sorry. They're
just too weird and too wacky. So
flooding just doesn't let you do
that right now. But now that
we've saved our storage variable
into a memory variable, we can
read and write from this memory
variable, much, much cheaper,
and then update storage when
we're all done. So what we're
going to do now is we're gonna
say for you into V six, fund or
index equals zero, and we're
going to basically rewrite
everything but just using this
memory array. instead. We're
gonna say funder index is less
than funders dot length and
instead of s funders dot length,
and then we're gonna say funder
index plus plus. And then in
here we're gonna do nearly
exactly the same thing, except
we're gonna say address funder
equals funders, using our memory
array and not s funders have
funder index. And then we're
gonna say s address to amount
funded. funder equals zero. So
we're resetting our funders
mapping here, we're using our
memory variables instead, then
we're going to do the same thing
s underscore funders equals new
address array of zero. And then
we're gonna do the same thing
bool success, comma equals S
owner, dot call value,
address this balance, and we're
going to send it nothing and
then require success. Like that
actually, sorry, Iona on a sonar
now that we have this function
that we think is cheaper, let's
go back to our test. And let's
run this same multi test here,
but with our cheaper function.
So I know this can be a little
bit tricky to copy, paste, but
let's copy this entire massive
test. Let's come down here,
paste it, and we'll change the
name saying cheaper withdraw,
testing dot that done. And in
here in in this giant it here,
all we're going to change is
we're going to change withdraw
to cheaper withdraw, and the
rest of the test is going to be
exactly the same. So with that,
let's see if if we were
successful in making our
withdraw function cheaper with
cheaper withdraw, we're gonna
pull apart our terminal now. And
we do yarn, art hat test, which
is going to run our gas
estimator because it's enabled
right now. And of course, all of
our functions have been broken
because we renamed everything.
So we'll do a quick final
replace of funders, to change
funders to ask funders. And then
we're gonna change price feed to
ask price feed. And then do we
have owner anywhere? We don't
have owner or anywhere. We need
to change this one. Address to
amount funded. Let's come in
here. Address to amount funded.
S adderstone. well funded. What
else do we need to change price?
We price feed funders. Okay, I
think we changed everything.
Alright, so let's try our test
now. Yarn Hardhead test. All
right, great. Everything's
passing. And we ran our cheaper
withdraw testing. So now, if we
go to our gas output here, our
gas report, zoom out just a
hair, we can see the difference
between cheaper withdraw and
withdraw, we see something
really interesting. Here we see
our cheaper withdraw on average
was actually more expensive than
our regular withdraw. And the
reason for this is because
actually, if we go to our tests
are cheaper withdrawal, we only
tested on the multi withdraw. So
we had to reset many, many more
accounts. But this was also
technically its maximum as well.
And if we compare the maximum of
the cheaper withdrawal, the
maximum of the withdraw, it
looks like the cheaper
withdrawal was indeed cheaper.
And if we go to our hard hat dot
config, and we add our API key
back in, what we could even do
is in our test, we could copy
withdraw eath from a single
funder, copy that, paste it in
and just change withdraw to
cheaper withdrawal, rerun it
with the key and now do yarn
Hardhead test, we can see
exactly how many dollars we
would save if we ran this on the
Matic blockchain. Now let's go
back, we'll reopen up our gas
report. And we can see, in the
minimum cheaper withdrawal was
actually a little bit more
expensive. This actually does
make sense because if we look at
funding, if we only have to
withdraw when there was one
funder, well this loop only runs
one time. And our cheaper
withdraw will do the exact same
but it will have this this extra
thing here of loading them all
in, we see that the savings The
more people our funders in our
contracts. So automatic, we can
see we pretty much didn't save
anything. But if I change this
one more time to eath run the
test again. Now we can see
people withdraw saved a few
cents. This is how we can start
optimizing our contracts will be
cheaper and cheaper. And this
two cents was just in the
average. It's not even comparing
the max to the max, which was a
lot more gas than their
averages. We have just learned
an absolute ton here. Now, this
next part is going to make some
of you mad because we're going
to refactor our code one more
time if you don't want to
refactor it and you want to
leave all your tests as s
underscores you absolutely can
but to other users using our
application. Dealing with this s
underscore is a little Little
bit gross and actually can make
our code a little bit more
confusing for those who use it.
And additionally, right now all
of our state variables are
public. And actually internal
variables and private variables
are also cheaper gas wise. And
we don't need to make every
single one of our variables
public, because anybody can read
them off the chain anyways. So
one more refactoring that we're
going to do is we're actually
going to set the visibility of
these to private or internal,
based off of whether or not they
need to be private or internal,
and then we'll create getters at
the bottom of our function here.
So minimum USD, we can keep this
public because we want other
people to know what the minimum
USD of our contract is, without
having to go right through
storage, the owner of our
contract isn't important for
others to know or other
contracts to know. So we can go
ahead and make this private, and
then at the bottom at a function
get owner. That's a public view
that returns I owner, turns
address as funders, as funders
can be private as well. So at
the bottom, we're gonna say
function, get funder, and we're
going to pass a un 236 index,
public U, turns, address, return
as funders of index, the address
to Mt funded can also be
private. So the bottom, we're
going to create function, get
address to amount funded. And
this is going to take an address
under the public view returns,
you went to 56. And we're going
to return amount funded of the
funder did this one we did this
one, we did this one. And then
price feed, function get price
feed. This is going to be public
view as well, that returns
aggregate tour of the three
interface that's going to return
so I'm just gonna price feed.
Oh, okay. The reason why we did
that is because we want to have
this s underscore so that we as
developers can know, okay, this
is a storage variable, I want to
be very careful about how I
interact with this. But we don't
want people who interact with
our code to have to deal with
this s stuff. And we want to
give them an API that makes
sense, and that it's easy and
readable. So we add these getter
functions at the bottom to do
that. And also changing the
visibility can save us some gas
in the long run as well, because
we're gonna be calling from
private variables or internal
variables, which are cheaper gas
wise, of course, we do need to
upgrade our test one more time.
And like I said, if you want to
just leave them with the S
underscores, that's absolutely
fine. So s underscore price feed
is now going to be replaced with
get price feed, s underscore
amount to fund it is going to be
now replaced with get address to
amount funded. For now going to
change SW, underscore funders,
to get funder. We're going to
change Iona, there's nowhere
else in their mind, we don't
need to change them. And I think
that was everything. Let's just
look for s underscore, we don't
see it, I underscore, we don't
see that either. Let's just run
our tests one more time to make
sure we refactor that correctly.
And it looks like we did
awesome. Okay, we have just
learned a ton. we've refactored
our code a ton. And everything
is starting to look really,
really good here. One more gas
optimization we could make. And
an optimization for errors as
well is we could update all of
our requires to instead be to
instead be reverts. Because
without requires, we're actually
storing this massive string,
this massive array of text on
chain, these error codes are
much cheaper. But that's
optional. If you want to do
that. The whole reason we were
doing this is we were going
through the style guide in
updating things here. So we have
public internal private, and the
bottom is going to be our view
slash pure functions, which they
are they're just all these
getters that we just added.
So now our style in here looks
good. We've learned a lot about
gas, we've learned a lot about
storage. This is fantastic.
Let's do a quick refresher on
everything we just learned
because we went through a lot
right there. And like I said,
this is one of the harder parts
of this course. Any variable
that is changeable that we want
to persist across contract
executions and transactions. We
save to a giant array called
storage this array is
sequentially indexed starting at
zero. So the first variable the
first value that we have in our
contract gets stored to the zero
with index. The next one gets
stored to one and so on and so
forth. Dynamic arrays and
mappings and other dynamically
sized objects use specific
hashing function that you can
find in the documentation to
determine where the elements of
those dynamic Data Structures go
memory variables, constant
variables and immutable
variables don't go in storage.
And one of the main reasons
talking about storage is so
important is because the op
codes for loading from storage
and for reading from storage and
writing to storage are
incredibly gas expensive. So in
everywhere we can we want to
reduce the amount that we read
and load from storage. And it's
one of the easiest ways to save
gas and try to optimize our code
to be gas efficient. Like I
said, some of this gas stuff can
be a little tricky and a little
bit confusing. So if you don't
get this right away, it's okay.
It is totally fine. If you're a
little bit confused, and you're
like, What is he talking about?
Like I said, this is some of the
more advanced stuff it'll come,
the more you work with solidity,
and the more you work with
everything here. So don't let it
stress you out. Don't let it
stop you from continuing. You're
doing fantastic being here. So
far. We've written some really
good unit tests. Let's now write
some staging tests. And these
are the tests that we can use on
an actual test net. This is a
test that we're basically going
to run after we've deployed some
code just to see if everything
is working approximately the way
we want it to. So let's go ahead
and we'll create a new file
here. We'll call it fund me. Dot
staging dot test, dot j s. And
it's going to look really
similar to what we were just
doing with our unit tests. And
we're going to assume this is on
a test net. So these are tests
that we're going to run, right
before we deploy this to a main
net, this is the last step in
your development journey, we
want to just make sure that
everything is working
approximately correctly on an
actual test net. So what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do the
same thing describe, fund me,
and I'm gonna go a little quick
through these tests here,
because we've basically written
this type of test before, so
we're gonna say before each,
it's gonna be an async.
function. We're gonna do the
same thing as our unit tests. So
we're gonna have a Funmi
variable, we're gonna have our
let Deployer, we're gonna have
our constant send value equals
ethers.utils.rs ether of one,
and in here, we're going to do
const. Get named accounts.
Equals require hardhats, we're
going to say deployer equals
weight, get named accounts,
we're going to wrap this up, dot
Deployer. We're gonna say fun me
equals await ethers dot get
contract.
And me, comma, we're going to
connect it to our Deployer,
we're not going to deploy this,
we're not going to do any
fixtures like we did in our unit
tests, because in our staging
tests, we're assuming that it's
already deployed here. And we
also don't need a mock because
on a staging, we're assuming
that we're on a test net, now we
can actually wrap this whole
thing to make sure that we're on
a test net by using our helper
config. And looking for our
development chains, we can say
we only want to run our describe
bit if we're on a development
chain. So first, we'll say
const. Development chains equals
require, we'll pull that that
helper config in. And we'll say,
development chains dot includes
network dot name. And we'll
basically will say if developer
chains that includes network dot
name, we're going to skip and we
can actually skip using this,
we're going to use something
called a ternary operator is
basically like a one liner if
statement. And you can think of
this as a special type of F.
I've got a link to this and the
GitHub repo associated with this
course. And here's some
JavaScript documentation,
showing it in action. You say,
Okay, return is member. And if
it's true, have it be $2.
Otherwise have a B $10. And
that's pretty much it. So
another way of thinking about is
like, you say, let variable
equals true, then we could say,
let some var equals variable
question. Yes? Or no? Some var
will end up being Yes. Because
variable is true. If variable
was false than some var would be
no. So it's literally saying, If
variable, if variable, then some
var equals yes. Else. Some var
equals no, these lines are
literally the exact same thing.
This one is just a little bit
more succinct. That's really it.
So that's what this operator
does. We're gonna say
development chains that includes
network dot name. So if our
network is a development chain,
which we're going to import
network as well from hard hat
and ethers as well. Then we're
going to do describe that
skipped and this tells our test
to just skip this whole
describe, and then we're going
to put this little colon here
thing and save and boom. So now
we're only going to run this if
we're not On a development
chain, and we want to take this
exact same syntax, we'll go to
our unit testing here, and we'll
do the exact same thing, we'll
paste it will have this be the
opposite by putting a little
knot here, sticking that colon
in. So now, our unit tests only
run on development chains in our
staging tests, only run on test
nets. Perfect. That's what we
want, allows people to fund and
own and withdraw. And this will
be an async function, of course,
and we probably can make this
pretty robust, but we'll just
say await, fund me dot fund is
going to be send a value. And
then we'll say a weight on me
dot withdraw. CERT equals
require try. Now we'll do kind
of a lame final one, we'll say
const ending balance equals a
weight on me dot provider dot
get balance, fund me dot
address. And then we'll say
assert dot equals ending
balance.to string, comma zero as
a string, we're only going to
run this on a test net, I'm just
going to give you this one more
run to show you it in action.
Feel free to skip this part
again, because we are going to
be working with a test net, I'm
going to run yarn, hard hat
deploy dash test network
Rinkeby. And it's going to run
through our deploy. And after
it's all deployed, we're going
to run our staging tests to make
sure that everything works even
with a price feed on a real test
net, and I need to do const
development chains equals
require dot dot slash dot dot
slash helper heart config. Now
for run yarn, hard hat test,
we'll see just our unit tests
get run. But if we run yarn hard
to test dash dash network
Rinkeby, we're not going to run
nine tests, we're only going to
run our singular staging test.
And of course, this is going to
be a lot slower, because we're
on a
test net. Net will we write
written all these tests, we can
write a couple of scripts. And
then we're going to finish this
out by pushing this up to GitHub
making this our first smart
contract GitHub repository, when
it comes to the blockchain, when
it comes to smart contracts,
interacting with community
interacting with open source
being a part of GitHub, or git
labs or whatever Git hosting
service you're using is
essential to being successful
here. So let's write our
scripts. And then we'll upload
this to GitHub to start building
our portfolio. So first, we're
going to create a script to
interact with our code called
fund dot j s. And this is going
to be really similar to our
tests. And this way, in the
future. If we want to just fund
one of our contracts very
quickly, we can just run this
and we can do it, we're gonna do
the same thing that we've been
doing, we're gonna do an async
function main. And down below,
I'm just going to copy paste
this because we're going to be
copy pasting in a lot. We're
going to paste this little
syntax here. So let's write a
script that allows us to fund
our contracts. So first, we're
going to need const get named
accounts just like in our tests,
equals require arhat we're gonna
say const Deployer. Equals await
yet named accounts, just like
that. And then we're gonna say
const fund me equals await
ethers dot get contract. From
funding comm a Deployer.
Literally, almost exactly the
same as our tests, then we'll do
a little console dot log funding
contract that that and we'll do
const transaction response
equals await funding dot fund.
And for the value, we'll do
something like ethers dot utils,
that parse ether of 0.1 or
something, whatever you want to
do here, we of course, need to
import ethers, which it looks
like we already have. We'll do
await transaction response dot
wait for one transaction. And
then we'll do console dot log
funded, we can run this little
script by running yarn, RT head
node will run a local node with
all of our contracts deployed.
We'll see if our script looks
okay by running yarn, hard hat
run scripts fund dot j s dash
dash network localhost. And it
looks like it's funding Great.
Let's now write a withdraw
script withdraw that J S. And we
can even leave our localhost
Node running because we're going
to withdraw the funds that we've
just funded it with. So we're
going to do the exact same setup
here. We can even copy this main
bit to our withdraw Ah, the top
will do async function main will
say const deployer equals await,
get named accounts, which wow, I
hit enter and my VS code auto
imported it, that's pretty nice.
Maybe yours will too, maybe
won't if it won't, you just
gotta write it out or copy paste
from the other one. And then
we'll do cars Funmi equals await
ethers dot get contract on me,
course. And this is going to be
the exact same. Now we're going
to do console dot log funding
data dot, we'll say const
transaction response equals
await on v dot withdraw, await
transaction response dot wait
one, then console dot log. Got
it? Back. And we can test this
out by running yarn, hard hit
run scripts, withdraw dash dash
network localhost, we'll see if
this works. And cool and our
script is working. Fantastic
crushed out two scripts
incredibly quickly. And now we
have a way to easily interact
with our code with our contracts
if we want to via a script.
There's actually one more thing
I want to show you before we
actually work and we push all
this wonderful code up to GitHub
in our package dot JSON. I've
shown you a little bit of this
before, but we can add this
scripts section to make our
lives a lot easier and condense
all these long tests into a yarn
script for us. So usually, what
you'll see in common package dot
JSON is you'll see a list of
these in here for people to look
and just automatically run, one
of the most common ones is going
to be test. And to run test,
we're going to do yarn, hard hat
test. So now instead of running
yarn, Hardhead test, someone can
just come to your package once
this is saved and just run yarn
test. And this will grab this
test from your script section
and it will run yarn heart at
test and Bada bing, bada boom,
okay, cool. What else do we
probably probably want to do in
here? Well, we probably want to
have a test staging section
that'll run yarn Hardhead test
dash dash, network Rinkeby. I'm
not going to run that. But
that's probably something we
want to have in here, we're
probably going to want some
linting. So we showed you
briefly that linting thing. So
we'll have a yarn lint, which
will just run yarn, sole hint.
And then we'll just have it so
hence the contracts folder. And
anything that starts out soul.
So now if I run yarn, lint,
it'll run soul hint, and all of
our code here and it'll give us
some warnings here, which we can
pretty much all ignore. And
Solon actually has an auto fix
and auto fix that we can add, by
doing yarn lint fix, we'll say
yarn. So hint, contracts slash
start out. So we'll do dash dash
fix. So now we run yarn, lint
fix, it'll auto fix, which
there's nothing to auto fix. So
nothing happens. But it's good
to have anyways. And then we can
do our formatter, we're just
going to format our code format,
that which will do yarn,
prettier, dash dash write to,
and we'll just do a period to do
everything. And then we can just
do yarn format. And it's gonna
fix all of our, it's going to
fix everything for us, which is
great. And then we finally can
have coverage. By running yarn
hardhat coverage, now we can
just run yarn coverage, will
give us this wonderful little
coverage report. Awesome. So our
packages looking fantastic.
Maybe we'll even come into
package json. We'll give this a
name. We'll call this hard hat.
And me give it an author, which
is going to be your name. So I'm
just gonna say Patrick Collins,
and we'll give it a version in
here. of 1.0 Point Oh, oops. And
let's do icons instead of
spaces. Oh, and one more thing.
We're not using ES lint. So all
this es lint stuff, we can dump
and we could delete the yarn dot
lock and reinstall. But yeah,
whatever. We don't have a
readme, but that's okay. If you
want to go back, like I said, go
check out that best readme
template and go update your
READMEs to make them look as
awesome as this, you can do that
as well. But other than that,
we've got an awesome code repo
here. What do we want to do with
it? Well, we've been playing
around with GitHub so much,
we've been looking at all these
good hubs. It's time for us to
join GitHub with our own with
our first repository. Let's go
ahead and let's make this happen
in the lesson seven full
blockchain solidity course, yes,
there is a link to this GitHub
Quickstart that we're going to
follow to set up our first
repository. This is going to be
the moment where you are
starting to build your portfolio
building and GitHub is
borderline crucial for your
development journey. It's going
to be your portal folio, it's
going to be where you say, Hey,
look at all the cool products
that I'm engaging with, that I'm
working with, that I'm
participating in. If you've
already made GitHub before, I
highly recommend you still push
this up to GitHub as proof that
you've done it. And then you can
also tweet it at me saying, hey,
look how far I've gotten. Look
where I've done, look at how
fantastic I'm learning smart
contracts, and be incredibly
excited about now, this
quickstart will walk you through
creating a repository, creating
a branch and teaching all this
stuff, we're going to follow the
instructions from the GitHub
documentation about adding
locally hosted code to GitHub,
we already have a project, and
we're just pushing it up. Since
the Windows users are using WsL,
you can just follow the Mac or
Linux instructions here, the
first thing that we're going to
do is in your GitHub profile, or
your GitHub login, we're gonna
hit this little plus thing, and
hit new repository, you can call
this whatever you want, let's
call it hard hat, fund me b code
camp, you can put a description
if you want, learning from
recode camp, and Patrick, about
smart contracts.
We'll make it public because we
want other people to see you
being fantastic and learning
smart contracts. We'll leave
this blank, and we'll hit Create
repository. Now, this is our
public code repository. This is
our first one, if you've done
these already, this will be your
first smart contract one. It
even has some instructions in
here, too, that teaches us how
to create a new repository from
the command line, you can follow
this if you want, or you can
follow like so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going
to initialize a git branch. And
from way back when you should
already have Git installed.
Remember, you can check by
running git dash dash version
like this. Git is a little
different from GitHub, Git is
known as version control. And it
allows us to make changes to our
code, but keep a history of all
the code changes that we've
made. GitHub is a place where we
can push all of these changes
and keep track of all of our
code. So the first thing that
we're going to do is we're going
to create a new branch. And I'm
not going to explain Git and
working with Git too, too
deeply. But if you want to learn
about Git Free Code Camp, of
course, has a video on Git and
GitHub for beginners. So we're
going to create this new branch
with git init dash b main, now
your Visual Studio code might
automatically start formatting
some stuff. And if it does,
that's great. And if it doesn't,
don't worry about it. But what
you'll see here on the left is
you'll see some stuff is green,
and some stuff is gray, open
back up that dot Git ignore,
you'll see that all the gray
stuff is the stuff that we have
in this dot Git ignore this is
intentional, this is what we
want. This is just some some
highlighting saying, hey, this
green stuff is what you're
working with on GitHub. And this
gray stuff is what you're not
working with and GitHub. And
that's what we want. You don't
need to push artifacts, or cash
or coverage or node modules,
people can install and compile
on their own machines, we
definitely don't want to push up
our Dotty and V if we're using a
Dotty and V. And we don't really
need to push up coverage dot
JSON, either the rest of this we
do. So now what's next, after we
initialize our main branch, you
now should be able to run git
status in your terminal and see
this huge red output of all
these things that are untracked,
and we don't have any commits
for, what we can do now is we
can stage all of our code with
git add period, and then commit
it with Git commit, we're going
to run these one at a time
instead of together. Before I
run git add, I'm going to add
deployments to this list too,
because GitHub doesn't really
need to know about all the
different deployments I make,
especially when I make a ton of
deployments to my local hosts,
they don't need to know. So
we're going to add that to, then
we're going to run git add dot.
And if we do a git status, now,
we can see all of our code has
been staged for being committed
for being a part of this history
of our code. And then take a
quick look at all these files
and make sure your dot E and V
file is not and never in here.
So now we're going to run git
commit dash m and then this
message for our commit, okay, so
we'll run git commit dash m, we
can say, initial commit, or
whatever you want in this
message here, first commit,
initial commit, who cares, and
it's gonna say, create mode,
blah, blah, blah, for all of
these files. And if we do git
status, now, it's blank on
branch main, nothing to commit.
And then you might get something
like this. If you've never
worked with Git before your name
and email were added
automatically. We're a little
bit confused here. We'll talk
about this in just a second. So
next, what we can do is we're
actually going to copy the URL
of our GitHub repo. So you can
grab that just by copying here
or right at the top, that URL
right there. And what we're
going to do is we're going to
add this as a remote repo. To do
that. We'll do git remote add,
and we'll give this remote repo
a name. For us. We'll say origin
and then we'll paste that URL
there. We're now saying the the
origin remote repo is good.
Gonna be at this URL, we run git
remote dash v, we can see that
the origin repo for fetching is
at this branch. And the origin
repo for pushing is also at this
branch. So when we want to get
new code, a fetch code will
fetch it from here. And if we
want to push code up, we want to
give code to the GitHub. We'll
also get it from here. So now
we've set the new remote with
that remote URL. Now we're going
to actually push the changes to
github.com. And the way we do
that is with Git push, and we
pick which remote we want to
push to, and we're going to push
the origin. And then which
branch we want to push to which
we're going to push to Maine,
it'll probably prompt you for
your username and your password,
and maybe your email and
everything. Now, if
authentication doesn't work for
you, for some reason, you can
come over to Settings. Or if you
scroll down to developer
settings, Personal Access Tokens
and create generate new token,
some token,
give yourself repo access, write
access, and hit Generate token.
And try to use this token as
your password. Instead, be sure
to use the GitHub documentation
and the GitHub discussion
associated with this course, if
you get lost or if something
doesn't work, as shown here. But
once it's done, once you add all
that information in correctly,
you come back to your get up and
you will have your first GitHub
repo with all the code and
everything in it like this. And
once you complete this step,
once you do this, you should
absolutely celebrate. If you
like, you can shoot a tweet web
three community in the
blockchain community is
absolutely this collaborative
space. So Twitter crypto is
where a lot of these people
congregate to share ideas. So
definitely be sure to celebrate
and share this and be really,
really excited. And shoot a
tweet out like this. Give your
friends a high five, share it on
Twitter, share it on Discord
shared on Reddit, be excited for
how far you've gotten, we've got
a lot more to go. But by
completing this part, you have
done fantastically, and I'm so
excited for you to start the
next section. Now, we're not
going to go over the TypeScript
addition to this because there's
nothing really new here.
However, again, if you want to
see TypeScript, feel free to
jump into the GitHub repository
associated with this course.
Alright, awesome. You've just
completed Lesson Seven, the
heart had fun me. And now it's
time to move on to lesson eight,
which is going to be our HTML
slash JavaScript to fund me, you
can find all the code for what
we're about to go through, of
course, on my GitHub repo. And
for this section, we're now
going to start to see some of
the differences between Node js
between that back end
JavaScript, and JavaScript in
the browser or front end
JavaScript. And if you come to
the GitHub repo associated with
this lesson, our main version
we'll be using what's considered
better front end JavaScript. But
we'll also have a no JS
addition, as well, if some of
the front end JavaScript is
really confusing, and you'll see
what I mean with some of those
differences very soon. Now,
people can programmatically
interact with our smart
contracts at any time. However,
most of our users are not
compete developers. So we need
to create a website, we need to
create a user interface for them
to interact with our smart
contracts and interact with our
protocols. And that's what this
section is going to teach us,
it's going to be an introduction
to building these fullstack.
building these front ends on top
of our smart contracts. Now, I
wanted to show you what this is
actually going to look like when
we finish it. Because here,
we're actually going to make our
first front end our first
website using the blockchain
using web three. And it's going
to be an incredibly minimalistic
website. As you can see right
here, we're not going to have
any styling, we're just going to
show you how to get the
functionality. And additionally,
we're going to do a couple of
things that aren't really
recommended and are definitely
not best practices. The reason
we're going to do it like this
is the same reason that in math
class, before you learn the
tricks for derivatives, you
learn what a derivative actually
is. We're teaching it like this
first, so that you can
understand what's going on on
the websites when you interact
with them. And when you work
with them. We saw already with
Foston, touching the link where
we can connect our wallets and
we can work with the faucets.
All decentralized applications
have this website and have this
setup where you connect your
wallet and then you interact by
clicking buttons, which make
these function calls to the
blockchain. And here's going to
be our minimalistic website that
does exactly that. So this
section is just going to teach
you what's going on under the
hood. So you can really
understand how to build these
applications at a professional
level. So for this section, if
you don't want to code along
with me, you definitely don't
have to however, coding along
with me will definitely ingrain
everything in your memory here.
So here's what an application is
going to look like. We have our
website here, which is connected
to our hard hat, our local
blockchain, but it's gonna run
exactly the same as if it was on
a real test net, the first thing
you'll notice is in our meta
mask, we are not connected. And
we'll go ahead and hit Connect,
and meta masks will pop up
asking us if we want to connect,
we'll go ahead and connect to
it. And now we'll be able to
interact with our heart at
Funmi. You'll notice two buttons
here are functions that we're
familiar with, we have our
withdrawal function, which is
going to be our withdrawal
function that we just created.
And then of course, we also have
our fund function here where we
push or we send Aetherium or
Matic or whatever, native
blockchain token to our smart
contract. So we can do it
through this user interface. So
once we're connected, if we want
to see the balance, we can
actually right click, hit
Inspect, come over to our
console. And we'll print out to
the JavaScript console, the
current balance of our smart
contract. So nobody has funded
this yet, we can come down, we
can choose an amount we want to
fund. So for example, maybe 0.1,
eath, we'll go ahead, we'll hit
fund, meta masks will pop up,
we'll get a little council
saying funding with 0.1. And
it'll give us all the
transaction details that we need
to send 0.1 eath, to our smart
contract, we can go ahead and
hit Confirm. And after it's been
confirmed after it's been mined
on our local blockchain, we had
get balance, we now see that
it's 0.1. We could call fund
again, we could have multiple
funders, we could switch between
different accounts and fund with
different amounts. And we can
see that funding amount
increase, then we can call the
withdrawal function. As long as
we're the owner, we can confirm
and we can pull out all the
money out of our funding
contract. And we'll get balance.
Now we'll see the balance is
reset to zero. So this is what
we're going to be building. Are
you ready? I sure am.
Let's get into it. This is the
introduction to building
websites with web three. All the
information here is available in
our GitHub repo, so feel free to
follow along there. Alright, so
if you're in your heart head
Funmi dash Free Code Camp repo,
we're still going to want to
have this open as well. But
we're also going to want to
create a new Visual Studio code
for working with our new repo.
So let's go ahead and CD down a
directory. We'll type MK dir,
we'll call this HTML, Fund Me
Free Code Camp. We'll cd into
that. And we'll open this up by
typing code period. You can also
do File Open Folder, but we just
want to open this up in a new
Visual Studio Code. New VS code
will pop up but before we flip
over to that, we do want to CD
down CD back into hard hat fun
we Free Code Camp because we are
still going to use everything in
here. We're still going to
deploy In a smart contract using
this folder and using this repo,
when you're building daps, or
websites that are connected to
the blockchain, you'll usually
have two repositories or repos.
One is going to be for the smart
contracts, like what we see
here. This is our repo that has
all the code for our smart
contracts. And then you'll also
have one for the front end slash
website. And it's going to be
the combination of these two
repos, which makes up the full
stack. So when people are
talking about full stack,
they're talking about the smart
contracts, which is going to be
our back end, plus, plus our
HTML slash JavaScript slash
website stuff, which is going to
be our front end. So smart
contracts are the back end, HTML
slash JavaScript slash website
stuff is going to be our front
end. So we have our back end
already. And now we're going to
build our front end, we want to
keep this up because we're going
to need it to test and interact
with our front end. Awesome. So
we have this new folder now,
HTML Funmi, Free Code Camp. Now
this course is not a how to
learn front end course, we are
going to teach you a number of
front end concepts. But if you
want to learn a full traditional
front end course, once again,
you can check out Free Code
Camp, they've got a ton of
fantastic tutorials, I'm
teaching you front end, if you
go ahead and follow along with
me, though, you'll definitely
get a basic understanding of
front end as well as front ends
and how it relates to our smart
contracts. Additionally, you
don't have to do the front end
parts or the full stack parts.
If you only want to take this
course, to learn back end and to
learn JavaScript, and to learn
solidity and learn how to do
these smart contracts
programmatically, then you can
absolutely skip these front end
parts. However, if you want to
learn to build exciting
websites, and you want to have
other people other than
developers interact with your
protocols, you definitely want
to watch this part. Now before
we actually jump in here and
start writing our code. We need
to understand what exactly is
going on when work with one of
these websites that use the
blockchain. So I actually made a
video about this recently. So
let's watch a segment from that
really quick, just so that we
can get up to speed with with
exactly what's going on behind
the scenes of these websites
that interact with the
blockchain. All right. So here
we are, with a website or a
front end on top of some smart
contracts that we've deployed,
doesn't really matter what it is
right now. This is typically the
interface that you'll see boiled
down to a really, really
minimalistic level. Typically,
you'll see something like
connect function, right, and
Metamask, or some other wallet
connector thing will pop up,
we'll hit Next we'll connect
here might even say something
like connected. And we can also
execute functions, we can
interact with our smart
contracts, we can confirm, etc.
Right? This is something you
might see something like Avi
right, I'll hit Connect on the
application, it'll say, hey, how
would you like to connect? I'll
choose Metamask. I'm going to
change my Metamask to main net,
but you get the picture, right?
This is a simple example of what
that would look like. So what is
actually going on in the browser
when we connect what is actually
going on? And what do we
actually need to do, we're going
to right click, hit Inspect. And
on the right side, we're gonna
see our debugger here. Now if we
go over to sources, on the top
of our browser, you'll see a few
things. If you look down over
here, right, we'll see this URL,
right, which right now is going
to be my localhost. And we'll
also see meta mask and Phantom
and a whole bunch of other
stuff. These other things that
we see here are going to be
what's injected from our browser
extensions. The reason we see
this meta mask thing here is
because I've meta mask
installed, right? The reason I
see Phantom here is because I
have the Phantom app installed.
Meta masks, of course, being an
EVM, wallet and Phantom being a
Solana based wallet. Now what
happens when we have these
extensions installed is they
automatically get injected into
a window object in JavaScript,
and in fact, we scroll down
to here in the console, again,
you can find console, you can
click here and click anything up
there. And we type in window.
We'll see we have this big
window object with all this
stuff, right? This window object
represents this our window
basically right? Now if we
scroll all the way to the bottom
and we do window dot Aetherium.
We also see an object here. Now
this window dot Aetherium object
only exists if you have a meta
mask or meta mask like browser
or if you want to look at some
other web three wallet you do
window dot Solana. So Alana
right and we see this window dot
Solana. Now let's look at a
browser that doesn't have
Metamask or phantom installed.
What do you think is going to
happen in the window now let's
go ahead and right click hit
Inspect. We'll go to the
console. Now let's see what's
going on in here. If we go to
sources, we first off we don't
see that Metamask or that Solana
source here. And if we go to
console, we still see window if
I let me zoom in a little bit.
We still see window here. But if
I do window dot Aetherium If we
get nothing, or if I do window
dot Solana, we also get nothing.
So in order for our browsers to
know that there's a Metamask, or
that there's a phantom, those
extensions automatically add
these to our window objects, and
that's something that we can
check for in our JavaScript. The
reason these wallets are so
important is built into them
underneath the hood, they have a
blockchain node connected to
them. And in order to interact
with the blockchain, we always
need a note. And you might have
seen URLs from alchemy, or in
FIRA because you need them to
interact with the blockchain,
Alchemy, and infura are examples
of third party blockchains that
you can interact with and
basically rent, right. But you
need them to create a provider,
or a node to send your
transactions to. So you could do
it in JavaScript, like something
like this is the alchemy
documentation where you take
that alchemy URL, you stick it
into some object and use that to
send your transaction. This is a
way that you could do it in the
back end. But on the front end,
what you normally want to use is
you just want to use the user's
Metamask, or their Solana or
their wallet as the main wallet.
Now, there are a ton of other
different types of wallets to
connect, like ledger, mu,
Coinbase, wallet, connect, etc.
And there are different ways to
set those up. But they all do
the same thing where they expose
some URL, they expose some node
under the hood, they give us
that URL. They give us that
provider. The way metamath Does
it is with window dot Aetherium.
Boom, this is now our URL. This
is now our connection. In fact,
if you go up to your Metamask,
hit the little three dots,
expand view. hit Add Network,
and then just hit the X so we
can get to networks. You can see
all of these blockchains that I
have in here all have an RPC
URL, this the HTTP RPC URL
connection of the blockchain No,
that's running. I happen to have
one running locally right now.
All of these also have a node
RPC URL and you can actually see
them right in your meta mask
right. This is connected to in
Fira, these are all connected to
in Fira. It's all the exact same
thing. Meta mask just has a
really nice way of taking that
URL, sticking it in the browser
for us in this window dot
Aetherium or window dot Solana
you know or whatever. So this is
the main thing that we need to
know we need. We always need a
connection with the blockchain.
And these browser wallets are an
easy way to do that. Make sense?
Great. Let's take this knowledge
now. And let's
apply it. So in here, let's make
a quick readme.md. Just so we
can talk about what we're going
to be making here. So in this
section, we're gonna be using
raw HTML slash JavaScript in
conjunction with our smart
contracts to build this website.
Later on. We will use next Jas
slash react, which is a more
modern stack to build our
websites here. But learning
understanding how to do
everything with HTML and
JavaScript first, is going to
make our lives a lot easier come
later on down the road. But as
we know, all websites use HTML
as kind of their scaffolding for
what they look like. So let's go
ahead and create our HTML for
our website, we'll call it index
dot HTML. And this is going to
be the basic scaffolding or the
basic bones of what our website
is going to look like. Now, in
VS code, if you go ahead and
just type exclamation mark index
dot HTML, and you click the
first thing that pops up, it'll
automatically populate your code
your file here with some basic
HTML setup. If it doesn't do
this for you, feel free to copy
paste the basic setup from the
GitHub repository associated
with this course, we have our
doctype. HTML, we have some HTML
tags telling us that everything
in between here is going to be
an HTML, which is great.
However, for simplicity, we
don't need most of this. So
we're going to make this a
little bit easier. We're going
to delete this line, this line
and this line. And we're just
going to change the title to
fund me app. And then inside of
our body, we can do something
like or Hello. And now we have
the bare bones to create a
website just with this. Now to
show this on a website, we can
do one of two things. If you are
using Visual Studio code, I'm
going to recommend you install
the extension live server. And
it looks like this. And I'll
have the extension ID for this
extension in the GitHub
repository associated with this
course, this is going to allow
us to easily spin up an HTML
website. So we'll go ahead and
install this. And if you're not
using Visual Studio Code, I'll
show you a different way in just
a second. Once this is
installed, you should have this
little go live button at the
bottom. And if you don't, you
can always open up your command
palette, which again, you can
open up by hitting View command
palette, and you can type in
live server and just say open
with live server but we're going
to just click this go live
button. And it's going to say
starting and it's actually going
to open up your browser with our
index dot HTML. We can actually
see our website is being called
Save on 120 7.0 point 0.1. This
is known as the loopback, or
local host endpoint, we're on
port 5501. If you're not
familiar with the ports, don't
worry about that for now, we
have our index dot HTML here.
And if we change this to
something like what's good, we
hit save. If it doesn't
automatically refresh, we'd come
over here and refresh. And we'd
see that being reflected here.
If you've never created a
website before, you've
essentially just done it,
congratulations, you might get
this.vs code folder. a.vs code
folder allows you to make
settings specifically for the
repo that you're working with,
for your code editor for VS
code, but we're going to mostly
ignore it for now. Now, if
you're not using Visual Studio
Code, what you can do is you can
just run this in the browser. So
one thing you could do is you
could right click it, and I'm
using a Mac. So I'm going to hit
Reveal in Finder, aka reveal
where it's located. And you can
just double click it, and boom,
now it's running right in your
browser. Instead of pointing to
your localhost, it's going to be
pointing directly to your local
file path. Now one final version
that we could do that I'm going
to highly recommend you don't
do. But it's another option,
we're actually going to download
a package for you using no Jas,
which allows us to serve up
HTTP. And we're gonna install it
the exact same way we've
installed our other packages, we
can do yarn, add dash dash dev
HTTP hyphen server. And you may
still want to add it anyways.
But now, we'll get some node
modules for this HTTP server
package, we'll get a package
json, and of course, a yarn dot
lock as well. And what we can do
is we can stop this down here,
stop that live server. And if we
go back to our website, refresh,
it'll now be blank. And we can
run yarn HTTP server. And this
will do the exact same thing.
And we get, and if we come over,
and we refresh, we'll see what's
good. Now this one is a little
bit more finicky. And after you
make a change, like, Hey, what's
good, you might have to close
it, and then reopen it and then
refresh. So I do recommend that
if you're on Visual Studio code,
you definitely just use this
little go live button, because
it'll reflect your changes a lot
nicer.
So let's go ahead and hit the Go
Live button. Hey, what's good
pops up. Okay, cool. Our HTML is
working perfectly.
So the title, of course, is
going to be the Funmi app, which
we see up here in the title
section. So let's update this
HTML, so that it has those
buttons, and it can actually
connect and work with our
blockchain and work with any
blockchain. Something else that
you can do in HTML is you can
actually write JavaScript inside
your HTML. And the way we can do
that is by doing this script
tag, and then we'll do a closing
script tag. And anything inside
here inside of our script tags
is going to be JavaScript. So I
could do something like console
dot log, hi, with a bunch of
exclamation marks, I'm going to
save it. We'll go back to our
front end, we're going to right
click, we'll hit Inspect, we'll
go to the console. And we can
see that Hi prints it out, we
refresh, we can see the hi
consistently printed out hi from
script tag, we'll save it, we'll
move back, we see hi from script
tag printed out. I know it's a
little bit small. So let me zoom
in. Alright, great. So we can
type our JavaScript in here,
it's inside the script tag is
where we're going to write our
JavaScript to write the
functions that our front end is
going to interact with. Now, as
we saw before, in this little
console, we can check for window
dot Etherium, to see if Metamask
or is installed. And again, a
lot of what we're working with
is actually right in the
Metamask documentation. If you
go to their basic section, they
talk a little bit about the
provider, which is this window
dot Aetherium, you can read how
to actually interact directly
with meta mask in the meta mask
documentation as well. Now using
window dot Aetherium is just one
of the ways we're actually going
to connect to the blockchain,
there's actually multiple ways
because there's multiple
different kinds of wallets out
there. But for now, we're just
going to pretend that window dot
Aetherium and meta mask is the
only extension out there. So
what we want to do is we want to
check to see if this wind of
that Aetherium exists. This is
the first thing that we should
be doing. Because if this
doesn't exist, this means that
they can't connect to the
blockchain, one of the first
things that we're going to want
to do is we're going to want to
check to see if that exists. So
we can do something like if we
can say type of window that
Aetherium does not equal,
undefined. Then we'll do console
dot log, I see a meta mask. So
now if we save, we come back to
our front end, we do see I see a
Metamask. I've got a Google
Chrome up without Metamask that
if we look in the console, and
we hit refresh it the same URL
where our live server is
running. We don't see that I see
a meta mask because it doesn't
see a meta mask. We can do else.
console dot log, no Metamask
refresh, we still see ICD a meta
mask where we have a meta mask.
You don't have to open up a
browser without one but we see
no meta mask for Chrome because
it doesn't see a meta mask. Now
what we could do is We can
automatically try to connect to
meta mask if we see that there
is a meta mask, right? Remember
how before, when we hit that
connect button meta mask popped
up and said, Are you sure you
want to connect? So what we can
do is, and you can, again, you
can find this in the meta mask
docs, we can run this eath
request accounts method, which
is basically going to be how we
connect our Metamask. Now, this
is specified by a new EIP and an
older documentations. And in
older tutorials, you might see
Aetherium dot enable, which
essentially does the exact same
thing. So what we could do here
is we could say, a cerium, or
excuse me, window dot Aetherium
dot request. And we could put
method F request accounts. And
we'll save that. Now if we go
back to our browser, we'll
actually see, you'll actually
see Metamask, go ahead and pop
up and say, let's connect so we
can choose an account. And we'll
hit Connect, will automatically
connect our meta mask to our
website. And now if we look at
our meta mask, we can see this
little connected thing. It's
saying that our account one is
now connected to our website.
This means that the website can
now make API calls to our meta
mask, we still have to be the
ones to approve them. But it can
go ahead and connect and try to
run transactions, which is
awesome, which is what we want.
If you want to disconnect, we
can go ahead and click that
little button and hit disconnect
this account. Well that we have
our code currently is anytime we
hit refresh, this is going to
pop up which is going to be
really annoying. So what we're
going to do instead is we're
going to wrap this up into an
asynchronous function, the exact
same as we've been doing, we'll
do we'll create an async
function called Connect. And
we'll wrap it up these curly
braces here. And then we'll just
format this a little bit to make
it look nicer. And now if we
save, we go back to our website,
and we refresh. And we go ahead
and disconnect.
If we refresh Metamask won't
keep asking us Hey, do you want
to connect Hey, do you want to
connect here do you want to
connect, because we need to call
this connect function where we
can do that is we can add a
little button here. So right
underneath our script tag, we're
going to add a button tag. So
this is the opening button tag.
And then here's the closing
button tag. And inside the
opening button tag declaration,
we'll give it an ID, which will
be Connect button. And we'll say
on click equals the Connect
connects function. And we'll
call this button connect in
between these little button
tags, we'll call it connect will
say when we click it will call
the Connect function. So if we
save, and we go back to our
front end, we can now see we
have a little Connect button.
And now if we press Connect,
Metamask is going to pop up,
we'll hit next and connect like
that. And boom, now we are
connected. And we can even do a
little await here so that we
wait for this to finish before
moving on. And then after we
connect, we can say console dot
log connected. So let's actually
go ahead and test this out,
we'll go back to Metamask. we'll
disconnect here, try to never be
on Main net if we don't have to
be. And let's go ahead run
connect, we'll hit Next connect.
And now we see a little console
dot log come out saying
connected. Okay, great. We can
also update our website
accordingly. So that we can let
users know that we're connected.
So we can grab the connect
button element ID and say that
we're connected once we're
connected. So after we await to
be connected, we can go ahead
and do document dot get element
by ID Connect button. And then
we'll say dot inner HTML equals
connected like that. And then
instead of saying no minimize
down here, we'll do just the
opposite. So we'll copy this
line. And instead of connected,
we'll say please install meta
mask. And we'll save we'll go
back to our front end, we'll hit
connect. And now if we're
already connected, it'll just
automatically go to connected.
If we're not connected, it'll
pop up, we'll get connected. And
now we have this button that
says connected, which is great.
So now we already know that
we're connected. So we've
connected our Metamask to our
front end. Now we want to
actually go ahead and do some
functions here. And this is
where we want to create some
more functions and some more
buttons that are going to use
ethers that package that we
become so familiar with. Now, as
we code, our script section is
going to get bigger and bigger
and bigger. So oftentimes, we
actually want to put our code in
a JavaScript file itself. So
we're gonna go ahead, come over
here, we're going to create a
new file, and we'll call it
index dot j s. And instead of
putting our JavaScript in these
script tags, we're going to put
it in this index and then import
this index file into our HTML.
And the way that we're going to
do that is we're actually just
going to grab this function.
We're going to copy it, delete
everything for now. We're going
to paste it into our end ext dot
j s, and then in our index dot
HTML, we're just going to tell
our script tag to use index.js.
So we're just going to say the
source is going to be equal to
dot slash index dot j s. And
then we're going to say, the
type of this is going to be text
slash JavaScript. Now if we save
that, and we save our index dot
HTML, we come back to our front
end, we do a little refresh. And
we make sure that we go ahead
and disconnect. And we do
another refresh, we can see that
even with our index.js in a
different file, because we're
doing src equals index.js, and
we're importing it into our
HTML, when we hit Connect, it
still calls our Connect
function. That's how we can kind
of separate our JavaScript into
its own js file that we're a
little bit more familiar with.
Now, if you look in the GitHub
repo associated with this
course, and you look in the
index dot j s, you'll see our
Connect function, we've added
some quality of life stuff,
we've added some try catches
just to make handling errors a
little bit better, you can go
ahead and add those try catches
in yourself if you'd like. But
I'm not going to demo them in
this video
here. Now we want to create our
fun function. And then later on,
we're going to create our
withdrawal function. And this is
where front end JavaScript code.
And no Gs are a little bit
different. In no JS, we've been
using this require keyword to
import dependencies in front end
JavaScript, you can't use
require, and it won't exactly
work. Now later on, we're going
to use the Import keyword, which
is really the better way to do
this. And this is where our
first differences going to be
using the Import keyword for
front end is much better than
the require keyword, especially
since the require keyword
doesn't actually work. And for
those you who might struggle
with this disconnect in this
change. Once again, in the
GitHub repo associated with
this, we do have a Node js
edition of this, where you can
use the require keyword, you
just have to go through the
readme and download some
packages and run some scripts
that basically transform your
code that uses require into code
that works with imports. But
we're going to teach you the way
to work with your front end code
here using imports. Now you'll
see when we get to next Jas that
we will still download code from
node modules and using a yarn
lock and a package json etc. So
summary in future seconds, we
are still going to do yarn add.
But outside of a framework when
we're using this raw JavaScript,
this raw HTML setup, like what
we're working with here, we're
not going to be doing yarn, add
node modules will add node
modules for framework like next
react. But for raw JavaScript,
we'll be using a different
syntax, which I'll show you
soon. So let's go ahead and
start building our fund function
here. To make our fun functions,
what would we normally do? Well,
we'd create an async function
called fund. And in this
function, we probably would want
to take some ether mount as a
parameter, because we're going
to want to fund it with some
amount of Aetherium. When we
call this function, we might
want to run console dot log will
do a little string interpolation
here. Funding with eth amount,
dot dot dot, these semicolons
are going to drive me absolutely
insane. So I'm going to add a
our dot prettier dot our rc file
into this, and I'm going to go
ahead and add prettier in here.
Otherwise, I'm going to lose my
mind. So we're gonna do yarn add
dash dash Dev, prettier, just so
we can format our JavaScript
with prettier come back to
index.js. I'm gonna hit command
S, and it looks like it does
indeed, auto format with
prettier now yay, no matter
semicolons, we can call this fun
function the same way we call
connect. So in in our index dot
HTML, maybe we'll create a new
button. Button. We'll give it an
ID of fund will say on click
equals fund. And we'll say fund.
And this will be our button
here, we save it, we're looking
at our front end. Now the fund
button that if we call, we say
funding with undefined because
we're not passing it an amount
here. So back in our index
console dot log funding with and
we'll just want to make sure
that we can actually call that
Funmi function. So we'll copy
this line again and we'll say
type of window dot Aetherium
does not equal undefined. We'll
go ahead and try to fund here to
send a transaction. What are the
things that we absolutely 100%
Always need? Well, we need a
provider slash connection to the
blockchain. And we need a signer
slash wallet, slash someone with
some gas to actually send it and
then And we're probably going to
need the contract that we are
interacting with. And to get
that contract, we're going to
need ABI and address. And with
these all together, we can send
any transaction. So to get our
provider, we're going to
actually go ahead and work with
ethers again. Now, we're going
to do it a little bit
differently, though, before, the
way we worked with ethers is we
said const ethers equals require
ethers, right. And this is how
we pulled ethers. And now like I
just said to you, though,
require doesn't work in the
front end. And we actually don't
want to install ethers with a
node modules package. So what we
can actually do instead is let's
go to the ethers documentation.
If you go to the Getting Started
section, scroll down, they have
a section about importing using
Node js, which uses require or
imports. And then they also have
some documentation for working
with the web browser. So instead
of us doing a node module, what
we'll do is we'll copy the
ethers library to our own
directories and serve it
ourselves. So what we do is we
can come in here, we can copy
this massive file, which is
ethers, but in front end
addition, and come back to our
file. And we'll make a new file
in here.
Called ethers. We'll do 5.6
point esm.min.js. And we'll
paste that massive thing in
here. Now, since I have prettier
when I save it, it's going to
auto format. And it's just this
huge file, which has everything
ethers, but front end defied if
you will. Now what we can do is
we can import this into our
index.js. So instead of using
require in here, we'll say
import ethers from and then
we'll just refer to that file
that we just got ethers dash 5.6
point esm.min.js. Now, we only
need to do this weird copy
pasting of the file import thing
in this HTML JavaScript lesson.
In future lessons with Node js,
we are going to do yarn, add
ethers, kinda like we've
normally seen. The frameworks
like React and next Jas that
we're going to use are going to
automatically convert those yarn
added packages to their front
end to five versions. But for
this section, this is how we're
going to actually import the
ethers package. Now the other
thing we'll have to do is on our
front end, we'll have to change
this from type text slash
JavaScript to type module
changes. The type module allows
us to import modules into our
code, which we're going to be
importing this, and we're going
to import another module as
well. Awesome. And now though,
if we go back to our front end,
do a little refresh with the
connect button, we get Connect
is not defined at HTML
button.on. Click, so instead of
calling our Connect button from
the front end here, we're going
to remove these on clicks from
our index dot HTML, and go into
our index.js and add those
connect buttons in here. So
we'll say const. Connect button
equals document, dot get element
by ID, Connect button. And then
we'll say const. One button
equals Doc, you meant dot get
element by ID. One button, the
idea of the connect button is
Connect button. The idea the fun
button is fun button. And then
we'll say connect button.on
Click equals connect. And one
button.on Click equals fond. We
go back to our front end, do a
little refresh. We'll hit
connect now. And it's actually
working, we'll go to our
Metamask will disconnect,
refresh, hit Connect, and boom,
it's popping up again. This is
just due to that type being
module, if it was text slash
JavaScript, that on click button
adding in here, but since we're
doing module, we're going to add
those on clicks right in our
JavaScript. But now that we've
got ethers in here, what we can
do is we can even do like a
little console dot log, just
paste ethers in here, or
actually better yet. We'll add
it right above the Connect
button. Go back to our front
end, we'll do a refresh and we
see the entire ethers object
right in our front end which is
perfect, which is exactly what
we want here. And since we've
got these two variables here, we
might as well update this to
just say connect button dot
innerHTML equals connected and
here as well. Connects button
dot innerHTML equals please
install meta mask because now
connect button is going to be
the same as running this
document dot get element by ID
right
here. and great. Let's go back
to continuing our font function.
So we'll say const provider
equals new ethers dot providers
dot web three provider, window
dot Aetherium. Web three
provider is an object in ethers
that allows us to basically wrap
around stuff like Metamask is
web three provider is really
similar to that JSON RPC
provider, which we use before,
which is where we put in exactly
that endpoint, our alchemy
endpoint, or when we're working
with Metamask. Here, whatever
endpoint that we have in our
network section is web three
provider takes that HTTP
endpoint and automatically
sticks it in ethers for us. So
this line of code basically
looks at our Metamask and goes,
Ah, okay, I found the HTTP
endpoint inside there, Metamask.
That's going to be what we're
going to use as our provider
here. Since our provider is
connected to our Metamask. Here,
we can get a signer or we can
get a wallet just by running
const signer equals provider,
dot get signer, this is going to
return whichever wallet is
connected from the provider,
which again, our provider is our
Metamask. So if we're connected
with with account one, it's
going to return account one as
the signer connected with
account two, it'll return
account two, etc. Now, I'm going
to add console dot log signer
here, and then flip to the front
end now and show you what
happens when we hit the fund
button. You can see in here we
have our JSON RPC signer, the
signer is going to be the
account that we've connected to
our front end. Now we have our
provider, we have our signer.
Now, we're going to need our
contract by getting the API and
the address. So we're gonna need
to say const. Contract equals
what? How are we going to get
our contract? Well, this is
where we're going to need to
know the ABI and the address of
a working with typically, what
you'll see a lot of projects do
since once a contract is
deployed, the addresses are
going to change is they're going
to have some type of constants
file. So they'll create a new
file called constants, dot j s.
And in here, they'll add the
addresses and any API's and
anything like that for us to use
in our fund piece here. Now, as
we're developing, and as we're
building, this, the backend and
the front end team are gonna
have to interact a little bit,
or if it's just you doing the
full stack, you're gonna have to
interact with their back end. So
this is why it's so important to
have both your front end and
your back end code nearby. So if
we go back to our Hardhead, fund
me project that we just made, we
can find the ABI in here. Once
again, if we go to artifacts, go
to contracts, we can go to fund
me dot soul, fund me dot JSON,
we can find the ABI right here,
it's going to be this massive
thing right here. So you can go
ahead, you can even copy this
whole thing in this little non
squiggly bracket and this little
bracket here, we can copy that.
And then we can come back to our
constant.js. And we can just
save it as variable, we'll say
Export const, Avi, e equals and
paste that in there. And then
back in our index dot j s, we
can import it with import
API from constants. Oops. Okay,
great. So we have the API. Well,
what about the address, since
we're going to be running this
locally, we want to get the
contract address of this locally
run contract, we can do that a
couple of ways. One way is you
can just have two windows open
one with your front end code,
one with your back end code, and
the one with your back end code,
you can run yarn, hard hat node,
which will spin up our
blockchain node for us, and give
us the address in here. Or what
we can do. And this will
probably be a little bit easier
is in your window with your
front end code and create a new
terminal. And now we'll have two
terminals running. And then this
second one, we're going to CD
down CD dot dot, and then CD,
hard hat on Me Free Code Camp.
And in here, we're going to run
yarn, art head node. And this is
going to spin up our local
blockchain in this second
terminal in here, where we have
deploying fund me deploy that
address, blah, blah, blah, right
here. And just a reminder, if I
hit this x, it just hides the
terminal. I can always pull it
back up with terminal new
terminal, and I can always hide
it, but this is still running
inside of my terminal. So I'm
going to hide it. And what I can
do is I can come back over to
our constants folder, and at the
top, we can do export const
contract address. equals, we'll
pull the terminal back up. And
we'll go grab, where it says,
pulling fund me deployed at
right here. We'll copy that
address, put some quotes, and
we'll paste it in. And now we're
also exporting the contract
address, then in our index.js
will import the contract address
with comma, contract address.
And now we have both the ABI and
the contract address. So what we
can do, we can say const
contract equals new ethers dot
contract of, we'll pass the
contract address, pass the API,
and we'll pass it the signer.
Now we have an ethers contract
object that's connected to our
signer, and we have the contract
address, and we have the
contract abi, now that we have a
contract object, we can go ahead
and start making transactions
the exact same way we've made
transactions before we can just
run const transaction response
equals a weight contract dot
fund. And then we'll pass a
value of ethers dot utils dot
parse, ether ether mount. So
this is going to be how we're
going to go ahead and create our
transaction. And if you take
this right now, and we go to our
front, we give it a little
refresh, make sure we're
connected and we hit fund, we're
gonna get this error value must
be a string. That's because at
the mount right now is being
passed in as nothing. Now
normally, we'll pass parameters
directly to our functions. But
what we're going to do is for
now is we're just going to hard
code this. So we'll say const.
At the mount equals, we'll do
like 77, or something we had
fun. Now, what do you think's
gonna happen? Well, we get this
other air, insufficient funds
for intrinsic transaction cost,
or you might get some other
error, but you're gonna get a
weird error here. And that's
because we're not actually
connected to our local hard head
node right now. Well, if we look
at our Metamask, we're currently
not connected to the right
blockchain, we're connected to
rink B, or main net or whatever,
we need to get connected to our
local host. If you look in your
networks, you'll actually have a
local host object here already.
But let's just be super
specific. And we'll add a new
network here, we're going to add
something called our hard hat,
local host. And we'll hit Add
Network and we'll add Hardhead.
Local host in here, the RPC URL,
we can find from our node area,
which we scroll to where our
node is running, we can copy
this URL and paste it into new
RPC URL, chain ID is going to be
31337 currency symbol is going
to be go or ether. Even though
this pop up says it might have a
different currency symbol go,
we're just going to put eath in
here. And there is no block
explorer, right? Because this is
a local blockchain, we're not
going to have a block Explorer.
So we'll go ahead and hit Save.
And now we have an account here,
which is great. We're connected
to our local blockchain. And if
we switch our meta mask, we can
see we're on the local hard hat.
And we are connected. Awesome.
Let's refresh. Let's run fund
one more time. And we'll see a
transaction does indeed pop up.
This is great. But our account
here doesn't have any money we
have, we're broke, we don't have
any local Hardhead Aetherium. So
we're actually going to need to
import one of our accounts from
hard hat into our meta mask,
which we can do so and you can
actually do this for any account
with a private key so hard that
gives us these accounts. And
we're going to import the
private key of Count zero into
our meta mask. So we're going to
copy the private key, we're
going to come back to our front
end, click on our meta mask,
we're gonna hit this big button,
we're gonna hit import account.
It's like type private key, and
we're gonna paste our private
key here. A quick note, if you
choose json file, remember how
back in that ether section, we
encrypted our key into a JSON
file with a password, you can
actually import accounts with
that JSON file with the
password. So if you encrypt a
key and you want to add it to
meta mask, you can go ahead and
add it in just like this. But
for now, we're going to use
private key, we'll paste the
private key in and we'll hit
import. And we can see we now
have an account, a new account
and account three, with a ton of
eath from our local blockchain.
So we'll refresh one more time,
we'll go ahead and connect,
we'll make sure that our account
three is connected. And if it's
not, we'll go ahead and hit this
Connect button. So that now our
account three is what's
connected here. And we'll go
ahead and hit fund. And we now
see that we can fund this
contract, we can go ahead and
hit Confirm. And if we look and
nothing's going to happen on our
front end, because we didn't
tell our front end to do
anything once we confirm, but if
we go to our blockchain, we can
see our fun function was called
we've just made our first
transaction on a blockchain from
our own front end, this is
awesome, great work. But it's
probably a little confusing to
the user. If nothing happens
here, they're going to hit the
fun function. And it's going to
be like, Oh, okay, cool. What,
what happens? Now, we probably
want to make it a little bit
more obvious that something just
happened. And one more thing I
want to show you, you don't have
to follow along here, if I hit
fund, and then I hit reject,
it's gonna freak out on us and
be like, hey, like, you hit
reject, I don't know what to do
now. So we're going to make our
code a little bit more robust by
adding a try catch. So we'll
tell JavaScript to try running
this transaction. And then if it
catches an error, just to
console dot log, that error. So
now, if I hit fund, and I hit
reject, it's gonna, it'll still
be a little bit mad, but at
least we're catching it and it's
not going to break and destroy
everything. Okay, cool. We've
got a transaction response here.
And when we hit fund, our front
end goes great. You've funded me
I'm I'm super confused. Oh, one
other point, something that
you'll probably run into
multiple times. As we're doing
this. If you get an error that
looks like this eath. JS query
while formatting outputs from
RPC, nonce to high expected not
to be too but got form, you will
definitely see this a whole lot.
Here's what you do to fix this.
The reason this happens is
because you've closed your
hardhat node and then restarted
it, and your heart had node
goes, Okay, well, I'm starting
fresh, I'm starting from zero.
But Metamask isn't smart enough
to know that, what we want to do
is we want to come to our
Metamask, we'll hit this big
button, we'll go down to
settings, we'll go to Advanced,
and we'll go to reset account.
And yes, we're going to reset
it. This isn't something ideally
that you'd like to do with an
actual account with actual money
on a local network, this is
fine. Now if you reset the
account, and you reset the node,
we can go ahead and hit Confirm.
And it doesn't give us that
error anymore. So that's kind of
the tip there, you want to reset
the nuts so that our Metamask
and our blockchain are in sync
with that nonce number.
So we have this transaction
response. And we probably want
our front end to give the user
some indication, hey, the
transaction went through. So
what we want to do is we want to
listen to the blockchain for
this to finish. So we can either
listen for the TX to be mined.
Or we can listen for an event.
We haven't learned about events
yet. But we will. So for now,
since we haven't learned about
events yet, we're just going to
listen for the TX to be mined.
Or to listen for the transaction
to be mined, we're actually
going to create a new function
called function, listen, or
transaction mine in this is
going to take as input a
transaction response, and a
provider. Now you'll notice this
isn't an async function. For
this section. This is
intentional, we don't want this
to be an async function. And
you'll see why in a second.
We're going to be using
JavaScript promise JavaScript
async functionality to its
massive advantage. And this is
why JavaScript actually works so
well on the front end is because
of how it's asynchronous. So
we're going to create this
function listen for transaction
to be mined, we're going to
await in our fund function. And
we're going to have this return
a promise. Let's go ahead, and
let's learn how to build this.
So we're gonna say console dot
log, string interpolation, we'll
say mining. And then in here,
we'll say transaction, response
dot hash. All of our transaction
response objects have a hash,
which just represent that hash.
And we'll do a couple of data
dot, we'll put in our console
here, we're waiting for the
transaction to be mined, then
what we're going to do is we're
going to return a new promise.
And the reason we're going to
return a promise is because we
need to create a listener for
the blockchain. We want to
listen for this event to happen.
But we want to tell JavaScript,
hey, wait for this thing to
finish looking, wait for this
thing to finish looking. Now
here's where this gets a little
bit tricky. In our fund
function. After we create the
transaction, we basically want
to tell JavaScript Hey, wait for
this TX to finish. So our code
is going to look as simple as
await listen for transaction
mine. And we're going to pass it
the trans action response
and our provider. So we're
saying hey, listen for this
transaction finish. And we're
using this await keyword,
because again, the await keyword
says okay, we're gonna stop
right here. We're gonna stop
until this function is
completely done. Now in this
listen for transaction in mind,
we have to define how we're
actually going to listen for
this. So we're going to say
listen for this transaction to
finish. Ethers actually comes
with a way for us to listen for
transactions and listen for
events, which again, we haven't
learned About, but don't worry
about that yet. So we can go to
the ethers docs. And we can look
up once. Contract dot once.
There's a whole bunch of
listeners that we can use to
listen for events and listen for
different things to happen, we
can do this thing called
provider dot once where we
listen for some event. And once
that event fires, we call some
other function that we've
defined. Now, we haven't talked
about events yet. And again,
don't worry about this quite
yet. One of the events that we
can wait for is we can just wait
for the transaction receipt to
finish, right, because once we
get a transaction receipt, that
means that the transaction has
actually finished going through.
So we're going to use this
provider dot once syntax to wait
for the transaction receipt,
which is going to be our event,
which isn't really an event, but
don't worry about that yet. And
then we're going to call some
listener function that we
defined, you can also do
provider.on, which will trigger
anytime your event fires
provider once just triggers one
time, we only care about this
transaction going through one
time. So we're passing our
provider object. So we're gonna
say provider dot once our event
which is just going to be
transaction response, hash,
provided on transaction response
dot hash. So once we get this
hash, which will pretty much get
right away, we're going to call
our listener function. Now we
can create a function listener
like this, and then just pass
listener in here. But we're
going to do an anonymous
function here, because that's
typically what we see as the
syntax for these loops. And so
far, we're doing provider dot
once to do this anonymous
function, we're going to do just
two little parentheses here. And
this arrow notation. So this by
itself represents an anonymous
function. So we're saying, hey,
there's some function, it
doesn't take any parameters, and
it doesn't have any code, this
arrow function, this whole thing
is saying this is an anonymous
function. So we're saying
provided at once transaction
hash happens, here's the
function that you want to
execute. It doesn't do anything
right now. But let's have a do
something. So once this
transaction dot response
finishes, we're going to take a
trans transaction received as an
input parameter, or our our
callback function, or our
listener function. And all we're
going to do is we're gonna say
console dot log, completed with
a little string interpolation,
transaction receipt, that
confirmations, confirmations,
and then completed with
transaction receipt,
confirmations, confirmations. So
once this provider dot once sees
that there's a transaction hash,
it's going to give as an input
rammer to our listener function,
the transaction receipt, kind of
that same syntax that we've been
seeing this whole time, once a
transaction response finishes,
we get the transaction receipt,
and we can do stuff with it. And
we see how many block
confirmations it has. For us,
this pretty much should always
be one. Now if we save this, go
back to our front end, and we
hit fund, it's going to work,
we're going to give the user
some indication that it worked,
which is great. But it's not
really going to work the way
that we want it to work. We have
this console dot log done right
after we do the await, listen
for transaction mine, and we
come back and we hit fund, we
hit confirm, it actually doesn't
go in the order that we want it
to go, it goes mining this thing
that it says Done. And then it
says completed with one trip
confirmation what what's going
on here, we should write
completed before we write done,
because that's the order that we
have this in. But it looks like
it's words, it's going out of
order. What what's going on
here, what's going to happen is
when we call listen for
transaction mine, or listen for
transaction, mine function is
going to kick off, but it's
going to kick off provided on
once as its own process. So
await listen for transaction,
mine will kick off the listener,
but it doesn't wait for this
listener to find the transaction
response. So this function will
actually finish before provider
dot once finishes. So after it
kicks off the listener, it'll
run to the next line of our
code, which is console dot log
and done. Our front end we'll go
oh, oh, you kicked off a
listener earlier. Let me go back
down and let me recheck to see
if it's finished. And if it has
finished, I'll go do what it
told me to do. And this is where
what's known as the event loop
kicks in.
We don't actually wait for this
provider that wants to finish,
we add this provided at once
onto this queue called the event
loop. And our front end is going
to periodically check back to it
to see if it's finished. So we
want to adjust our code. So we
wait for the listener to finish
listening, which is where we're
going to get into promises here.
So what we want to do is we want
to adjust this function to now
return a promise. And we're
going to use this syntax a
couple of times in the future.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to say hey, we want
to wait for the listener To
finish listening, we're going to
wrap this whole thing into a
promise. And we're going to say
return, new promise. And a
promise takes a function itself
as an input parameter. So again,
we'll use kind of this anonymous
function notation. And it will
take two input parameters
resolve and reject. So resolve
says, hey, if this promise works
correctly, call this resolve
function. And for us, this
promise is going to be done when
the listener finishes listening.
And then we would reject if
there was some type of timeout,
we're not going to write the
reject function. But in the
future, if you were to do this
for production, you'd add some
timeout as the reject parameter.
Basically, you're saying, hey,
once the listener finishes
listening, we're going to
resolve and if it takes too
long, we're gonna say ask for
you, you took too long, and
instead of closing it off, here,
we're going to close it off
around this provider thing. So
we're gonna say return new
promise, resolve, reject. And
only once this transaction gets
fired, are we going to resolve
this promise, like so. So what
is happening here, so we're
going to put the resolve inside
of this provider at once. So
we're saying, once this
transaction hash is found, then
we're going to call this
function, we're gonna say
console dot log, and then we're
going to resolve so this promise
only returns once a resolve or
reject is called. And we're
telling it only resolve only
finish this function once.
Transaction response dot hash is
found, because it's going to be
inside of these little squiggly
parentheses for provider dot
once, the promise right now only
resolves after it's fired. It's
event here. If this was really
confusing, just copy paste this
and move on, we're getting a
little bit deeper into front end
stuff here. So hopefully, this
was clear, if not definitely
jump in to the GitHub
discussions to start asking
about this stuff. But now that
we've updated this, we can come
back to our front end, we can
hit the fund button. And
hopefully this time, everything
will go in order. We'll hit
confirm, we see mining
completed, and then we see done.
And the reason for this is
because again, our await keyword
is now waiting, it says oh,
you're returning a promise, I
need to await I need to wait for
it to resolve or reject. And we
only resolve the promise once
our provider finds this
transaction hash and this
transaction receipt, this is
this listen for transaction
mine. In future sections, all of
this is going to be abstracted
away for us. So life is going to
be much easier, but it is
important to understand what's
actually going on here. Awesome.
So now we're giving the front
end some indication of what's
going on. Our fun function is
done well, no, not really. Why
not? Well, because right now
we're hard coding the eath
amount to 0.1. And on the front
end, we probably don't want to
hard code it, we probably want
to allow users to fund as much
or as little as they want. So we
actually need to change this
from just a button to a input
form. So to do this, we're gonna
go back over into our HTML. So
we'll go back to index dot HTML.
And we're going to change this
fun section here, we're going to
add some form information. So
we're going to keep this button
as it is, or we're going to add
like a little text box to input
as much eath as they want. So
I'm going to create a label,
we're gonna say it's for, it's
going to be fund and this label
we're gonna say, is eath amount,
and then we're gonna close
label, this is basically just
going to create a label. And if
we go back to our front end, we
now just have this Etham out
label that isn't labeling
anything. Now we're going to
create an input, and we're going
to give it an ID of eath amount.
And we're going to give it a
placeholder
of 0.1. And then we're gonna
close the input. So now if we
flip to our front end, we have
eath amount, labeling this
little text box with a
placeholder of 0.1. And we can
add stuff in here, you know,
blah, blah, whatever. And one
more thing, if you have some
tags, but you don't put anything
in between them, you can
actually shorten it by just
putting the little closing thing
at the back of it like this. So
if you don't have anything
between your tags, you can just
close them like this, these two
are equivalent, boom, boom,
boom, boom, those are the same
thing. Great. When we called
fund right now we're calling
fund and we're not passing any
parameters. Let's update our
fund to no longer be hardcoding
eath amount in here, and we'll
have and we'll have our fund
function populated by whatever
we put in this eath amount input
box in our fund function,
instead of saying const eath
amount equals 0.1. We'll grab it
from this eath amount ID and
we'll say document dot get
element by ID eath amount, dot
value. So we're going to grab
whatever value In this input box
here, now, in our index.js, we
have console dot log funding
with eath amount, if in our
front end, we do 1.7. And we hit
fund, we now see in our console
dot log, it says funding with
1.7. And we'll get 1.7. And our
little fun section confirm, it
will mine it, it'll complete it,
and then say, done. Awesome. So
now we've added a little text
box here. So people can fund as
much or as little as they want.
Perfect, this whole thing can
kind of be considered a form.
There's also a form tag, but
we're going to just use this for
now. All right, great. We're
doing a lot of funding right,
and we keep funding our contract
with more and more Ethan, we
keep adding more and more stuff,
we probably want a button to
keep track of how much is
actually in here. So let's just
add a really simple balance
button. And let me actually just
move this down to the bottom
here, much better. So we'll say
button, id equals balance
button. We'll call it get
balance. Now we have a get
balanced button. And it's not
going to do anything because we
don't have a get balanced
function. So let's go back to
our index.js. And we'll create a
get bounced function async
function get bounce. And we'll
just do what we've been doing so
far. If type of window dot
Aetherium does not equal,
undefined, then we're going to
do const provider equals new
ethers, ethers, dot providers
dot web three provider of
window, that Aetherium then will
do const balance equals awaits
provider dot get balance,
contract address, which again,
we're importing way up at the
top, and then we'll just do
console dot log ethers dot utils
dot format, ether, bounce this
format ether function ethers
utils, which you can find in the
documentation to make reading
ethers, formatted numbers much
easier to read. Then same as
what we've been doing before,
we're going to go up, we're
going to copy this fun button
line, paste it will say balance
button equals document dot get
element by ID, balance button.
And then we'll say balance
button on click equals get
balance, we're gonna come back
to our front end, we'll do a
quick refresh, we'll do get
balance. And now we can see the
balance in the console, we can
fund with more like 1.8, we'll
hit fund metamath pops up, we'll
go ahead and confirm mining
completed done, we hit get
balanced, and now we're at 3.8.
Fantastic. Alright, let's keep
it going. What do we need to do
next, we're gonna go ahead and
eat our withdrawal function
here. So let's create that this
is gonna look really similar to
everything we've done so far. So
on our index dot HTML, let's
create a new button that we can
do by copying this whole line,
paste it underneath, call this
withdraw button, we'll call
withdraw. And we'll call this
withdraw. And then in our index,
do the same thing, we'll copy
this, paste it below. So with
drop button was document get
element by ID, withdraw button,
withdraw button.on Click equals
withdraw. So let's make a
withdrawal function down at the
bottom. We'll go ahead, say
async. Function withdraw,
will do the exact same that
we've done above. And I can even
just copy everything from the
get balance and just remove the
balance section. If type of
window dot Aetherium does not
equal to undefined, then we'll
grab the provider here. And same
as the fund contract, we'll grab
the signer and the contract. So
let's just grab those two lines.
Paste them down here called
signer equals provider dot get
signer. Contract equals new
contract, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, cool. Now we're gonna do
the exact same here as we did
with the fun function. So we're
gonna do a little try, catch,
and then we'll even add the
catch here, catch error, console
dot log error. And inside of our
try, we'll do const transaction
response equals await, contracts
dot withdraw. We don't need to
put any parameters in here. Oh,
then actually, let's do a little
console dot log, withdrawing,
and then we'll get this
transaction response. And then
we'll listen for this
transaction to get mined as
well. By running a Wait, listen
for transaction mine transaction
response comma, provider And
that's it, since we can reuse
the functionality from our
listen for transaction mine. So
now we'll refresh, we'll make
sure we're connected, check the
current balance, which is 3.8.
Now we'll go ahead and withdraw.
We see our little withdrawing
console dot log, we'll hit
Confirm. And it looks like we've
completed it, if we look in our
Metamask, our bounced will have
been increased by the amount
that was added here. And now if
we hit balance, we do indeed see
zero, we can even double check
that this is actually working,
we can see our balance is 9.99.
Let's go ahead and even fund
this with 99 eath. Good confirm,
looks like it's completed. Our
meta mask now shows 99.00. And
if we go ahead and withdraw,
confirm, that withdrawal has
gone through, we can see our
balance is back up to 9999. And
now let's just go back and
change. Hey, what's good. We'll
refresh our front end. And now
we can see you've done it, we've
created a minimalistic website
that allows us to connect to the
blockchain and call functions
from a front end. And from a
website, this is absolutely
massive, you should be
incredibly proud and incredibly
excited with yourself. Now, this
is definitely a minimalistic
version. And we're going to work
with more powerful and more
modern front end frameworks. But
this will give you an idea of
exactly what's going on behind
the scenes when we're working
with those more advanced front
ends, and we'll style them up.
So they look a little bit better
than this. But with that being
said, you've just learned the
basics of how these front ends
work. And now that you know how
to push things up to get, I
highly recommend you start
pushing all of these projects up
to your GitHub, they will be a
record that you've actually done
the work and you've built these
smart contracts. And if you're
looking to get an internship
down the line, if you're looking
to help other GitHub projects,
this will be a record of hey, I
can do this, what I can build
look at what I know how to do so
congratulations on your first
full stack or your first front
end application. Before we move
on, let's do a quick refresher
of everything we've learned
here. So number one, typically,
you want the repository or your
code base. For your back end for
your smart contracts to be a
different repository than your
front end, your front end code
is going to be a combination of
HTML and JavaScript. When we
have a wallet like meta mask,
we're injecting these browser
based wallets into the window
object of our browsers like
window dot Aetherium. Each
browser will have a different
extension here, reason we do
this, we want to connect to the
RPC URL that's built into our
meta masks. And in this way,
we're making the same API calls
to an RPC URL as we do in hard
hat as we do in remix as we do
in ethers, etc, we created our
first promise based function
where we had a listener kickoff,
and we wrapped it in a promise
to say, hey, we want to wait for
our listener to finish since
this is a promise based
function, we set a weight listen
for transaction mind and we
waited for this transaction to
finish so that on our front end,
once our transaction finished
going through, we can tell the
user it's finished going through
and we can continue doing other
stuff. Give yourself that round
of applause and let's move on to
the next section.
All right, welcome to the next
section. We are now on Lesson
Nine, our hardhat smart contract
lottery, which again, all the
code for this section is going
to be available in the GitHub
repo associated with this
course. Alright, so let me show
you what we're about to build.
I'm going to show you the front
end login, you don't have to do
the front end, if you don't
want. But the front end does
give us a nice way to visualize
the lottery that we're building.
Here, we're building an
application that allows users
completely decentralized to
allow us to engage in a fair, a
verifiably random lottery. This
is the application that would
actually fix the McDonald's
issue that we talked about much
earlier. So first, we got this
Kinect Wallet button that we're
going to click to connect to
meta mask. And here, we're
actually going to show you how
to connect to more than just
Metamask wallet connect to trust
wallet, math, wallet, any of
these wallets, and we'll show
you how to customize even more.
So we're going to connect to
Metamask. Here, we'll choose our
account that we imported in from
Hardhead, we choose Next we're
gonna choose Connect. And
remember, for our front end bit,
we're gonna go to Settings
Advanced reset account, if we're
working with a brand new hard
hat blockchain. Now, the front
end doesn't look super nice, but
we have an enter raffle button.
And we have a little bit of UI
talking about the current number
of players and then the most
previous winner of a raffle. So
we can go ahead and enter the
raffle and allow anybody to pay
0.1 eath. To enter our smart
contract, we get a little
transaction saying transaction
complete, and we get the current
number of players is one, we can
continue to enter the raffle and
anybody can enter this raffle.
And this, the smart contract
will keep track of all the
players in here, we're going to
run this on a timer, the lottery
is going to automatically
trigger somebody to win. And to
do this, to get a pure
verifiable random number, we're
going to be using chain link VRF
to get a pure verifiably random
number. And then we're gonna use
chain link keepers to trigger
the automation to automatically
have one of these winners get
picked every time one of those
time intervals is up. Once the
keepers kick it off, they will
pick a winner, our decentralized
lottery will say the most
previous winner is so and so.
And they will get all the money
from this lottery making a
perfectly fair decentralized
lottery, we're going to call our
contract, raffle dot soul but
you can call it lottery dot soul
or really whatever you want. And
we're going to make it look
really, really nice. So now
we're back in our Visual Studio
code. This is going to be the
project. If you learn this, you
have the skills to learn all the
rest of the smart contract
concepts, and you are going to
be able to do great things in
the space. This is going to be
your flagship project, this is
going to be the one that you can
be the most excited and the most
proud about for this tutorial.
So let's go ahead and let's
create a new folder. So we're
gonna do MK dir, hardhat, smart
contract lottery, FCC or smart
contract, raffle, whatever you
want to call it, then we're
going to cd into our hard hat,
smart contract lottery Free Code
Camp. And we're going to type
code period, or we're going to
open this up in a new folder,
however we choose to do. So now
that we're in our new folder,
we're going to create our new
hard hat project. So we're going
to do yarn, add dash dash dev
hard hat. And we'll get our node
modules are package dot JSON and
our yarn dot lock. Now we'll do
yarn hardhat. To get started
with a new project, and we're
just going to select create an
empty hard hat dot config dot j
s because we know what a basic
project looks like. And we're
gonna give this project the
customizations that we want to
see, we're going to create an
empty hard hat dot config. And
now in here we have a blank
hardhead.config.js with almost
nothing in here. So we're
starting completely from
scratch. Now we're going to add
all of our dependencies in here.
And oftentimes, you'll add these
sequentially as you build but
we're just going to add them all
in one line, and there are a lot
of them. So we've left a copy,
paste the whole section of the
full blockchain solidity course,
J S, for you to just copy,
paste, so you can install
everything in one go. So grab
that line, and it's going to
have everything that we've been
talking about. And we'll just
hit enter, and we'll install all
of these.
And as you create more and more
projects, you'll get the feel of
what you like for your
dependencies and what tools that
you like to use. Remember, at
the end of the day, the tool
that's best for you and best for
the job is the tool that you
like the most. There never
really is a one tool fits all,
there's almost always going to
be trade offs. Alright, now that
we have all those dependencies
installed, if we look at our
package, JSON will have this
massive dev dependencies, we'll
have everything in Node modules
will have everything in yarn dot
lock. And of course, as we know,
in order for any of these to
actually work, we need to add
them into our Hardhead config.
Now, there's a lot of stuff to
add in here as well. So like
once again, if you want to come
to the heart at smart contract,
lottery, FCC, and go to the
Hardhead config, you can just
copy paste everything and place
it into your project so that you
don't have to always type
everything out yourself. Meclabs
Hardhead waffle anomic labs
started ether scan harder to
deploy slitted coverage, or had
gas reporter heart had contract
sizer, which we haven't talked
about yet. But we will Don't
worry. And then require dot env
dot config. And as you all know,
all these little semicolons are
popping up and those are going
to drive me absolutely crazy. So
once again, we can create a dot
prettier, RC. And if you want to
copy this as well, from one of
your previous projects are free
to do so. One thing that I added
in here was a print width of
100. This just changes how long
a line can be before it goes on
to a new line. That's the only
difference here. Now if we go to
our config and hit save, they go
away, thank goodness. Now if we
look at our solidity version,
we're currently using zero point
7.3. Let's go ahead and update
that to 8.8 or 8.7, or whatever
you want to use. Now that we
have all the basic setup, we can
begin coding our smart
contracts. So we first need to
create a new folder called
contracts where we're going to
store all of our contracts. And
let's go ahead and create a new
file called lottery dot soul or
raffle dot soul or whatever you
want to call it. I'm going to
call mine raffle dot soul. And
you might see this indexing
thing happened from time to
time. It's our hard hat,
solidity extension, indexing all
of our node modules. So it knows
how to highlight things and
knows how to work with
everything in our solidity
files. So that's what happens
when that pops up. Now before we
jump in and create it, let's
figure out what we're going to
do. So we're going to create our
raffle contract. And what do we
want people able to do? Well, we
probably want people be able to
enter the lottery, you know,
paying some amount, we're
probably going to want to be
able to pick a random winner.
But we want this to be
verifiably random, we want this
to be untampered with a bowl.
And we also want winner to be
selected every X minutes or
years or months, aka we want
this to be completely automated.
So we want to deploy the smart
contract and almost have no
maintenance almost have nobody
ever have to touch it again. And
it'll just automatically run
forever. This is the power of
smart contracts. As we know,
since we're picking a random
number, and we have some event
driven execution, we know that
we're going to need to use a
chain link Oracle, since we're
going to need to get the
randomness from outside the
blockchain. And we're going to
need to have that automated
execution. Because a smart
contract can execute itself, we
need somebody to automatically
trigger these. So to trigger
selecting a winner, we're gonna
have to use the chain link
keepers. And that's pretty much
going to be our entire code.
Now, I usually like to do this
before I start any project. And
the reason that I do a little
bit of brainstorming is because
we don't want to just jump in
and really do anything, we want
to have a good idea of what
we're trying to build so that we
can write tests for it, so that
we can know if we're going in
the right direction, etc. Now
that we have a good idea of
where we're going, let's build
it. So per usual, let's do spdx
license identifier. And my team
will do pragma solidity little
caret here, zero point 8.7, even
zoom out, just a hair will trash
that and we'll say contract,
raffle, we can even make sure
that we're not going crazy by
doing a little yarn Hardhead
compile and compiled
successfully, we want it to be
able to enter the lottery want
us to be able to enter it. So
maybe we'll create a function
called enter raffle. What else
do we want to do, we want to be
able to pick a random winner. So
maybe we'll create a function
called pick a random winner, and
boom. So let's comment out pick
random winner for now. And let's
just work on this enter raffle
thing. In the past, we've
created projects like Funmi,
where people can send ether to
our contracts or send whatever
native blockchain token to our
smart contracts using the
message dot value based off of
some USD value. For this one,
we're just going to have the
entrance fee instead be USD
based, it's just going to be
that native asset. So for our
enter raffle, we don't have to
set a USD price, we can just set
a minimum eath price. So up at
the top, let's pick our minimum
price. So we'll do a un 256
entrance fee. And now some of
our learnings from our last
section should come in here, we
now know that this entrance fee
is going to be a what, it's
going to be a storage variable.
So let's prepend it with s
underscore let's make a private
variable because we always want
to set our visibility. But let's
have the entrance fee be
configurable. Well, let's create
a constructor now. And we'll
have this entrance fee be
settable in our constructor, so
our constructor will take a UNT
two to the sixth entrance fee, s
underscore entrance fee equals
entrance fee. Well, if we're
gonna only set this one time, we
might as well make this a
constant or an immutable
variable. So let's make this an
immutable variable so that we
save some gas we'll change this
from S to I and now we're saying
you interviewed six private
immutable I entrance fee equals
entrance fee. Now we probably
are going to want other users to
see the entrance fee. So down
below, we can create function
get entrance fee, and this will
be a public view function which
will returns a UN to the set
Next, and we'll just say return
entrance fee. Now we have a
function that users can call to
get the entrance fee. But we, as
developers can use this AI
entrance fee to know this is an
immutable variable. This is
pretty cheap gas wise for us to
read from in our enter raffle,
we've done a ton of these
before, all we need to do is we
just need to require the message
dot value is greater than that I
underscore entrance fee, what
we've learned before about those
error codes, so we could use
require message dot value, or we
could do one of these customers,
which is going to be a lot more
gas efficient, because instead
of storing this string, we're
just going to store an error
code in our smart contract. So
let's do that. Instead, we'll
say if the message dot value is
less than our eye entrance fee,
then we're just going to revert
the whole transaction with some
error code. And we'll use a best
practice naming raffle
underscore underscore not enough
eath entered. And we'll grab
this arrow code. And we'll have
if the user doesn't send enough
value will revert with not
enough eath entered now that we
know they're calling into raffle
with enough value, we're
probably going to want to keep
track of all the users who
actually enter our raffle. That
way, when we pick a winner, we
know who's in the running. So
let's create an array of players
at the top error here. And then
just to make this look even
nicer, we'll do a little comment
here. And we'll say state
variables. And we'll combine
both our storage and are not
storage variables just in this
state variable section. So we'll
do address array players. Now
players, of course, is going to
have to be in storage, because
we're going to modify this a
lot, we're going to be adding
and subtracting players all the
time. So we're going to do s
players will make this private
as well. And we're going to make
this address payable players
because one of these players
wins, we're going to need to
have to pay them. So we'll make
this address payable private as
players. And since we're going
to make this private, and it's
probably good that we know who's
in the players array, we'll even
do function it player. This will
be a public view that returns an
address of one of these players.
And we'll just return s players
of index will have this
function, take a un 256 index as
an input parameter, we know that
players is going to be a storage
variable. And we're going to add
it to our enter raffle Oh, and
we definitely want our Inter
raffle to be public and to be
payable. Since we're having
people send message dot value,
and we want anyone to be able to
enter our raffle. So it'll be
public, it'll be payable, it'll
be perfect. Now that we have our
array, and someone's entered the
raffle, we'll do s players dot
push message dot sender. Now,
this doesn't actually work
because message dot sender isn't
a payable address. So we'll need
to typecast it as a payable
address just by wrapping it in
payable. So now we have a way to
keep track of all the players
that are entering
a raffle. Now one of the
concepts that we haven't gone
over yet is actually going to be
events. And events are really
important to our smart
contracts. Whenever we update a
dynamic object, like an array or
a mapping, we always want to
omit an event when we get to
less than 10. And then
especially less than 15 with the
next Jas and if T marketplace,
these events will make a ton of
sense, especially for front end
developers. So right now events
might be a little bit of a weird
thing for you as we explain it.
But as we continue on, they'll
start to make more and more
sense. So we're going to start
adding events to our smart
contracts. Whenever we update
one of these dynamically sized
data structures. And to learn
more about events and how to use
them. We're gonna watch another
video that explains all about
events. You can actually follow
along with this video as a side
project. But let's learn all
about events. Now, if you've
worked with solidity, you've
probably seen these things
called events before or maybe
you haven't seen something like
events. But you've always
wondered how chain link or the
graph or some of these other off
chain protocols work under the
hood. And in this video, we're
gonna learn about logging and
events in solidity, viewing
those events on ether scan, and
then working with them in hard
hat. Now it's the Ethereum
virtual machine, or EVM. That
makes a lot of these block
chains tick, like Aetherium. And
the EVM has this functionality
called a logging functionality.
When things happen on a
blockchain, the EVM writes these
things to a specific data
structure called its log, we can
actually read these logs from
our blockchain nodes that we
run. In fact, if you run a node
or you connect to a node, you
can make a F get logs call to
get the logs. Now inside these
logs is an important piece of
logging called events. And this
is the main piece that we're
gonna be talking about today.
events allow you to print
information to this logging
structure in a way that's more
gas efficient than actually
saving it to something like a
storage variable. These events
and logs live in this special
data structure that isn't
accessible to smart contracts.
That's why it's cheaper because
smart contracts can access them
so that If the trade off here,
we can still print some
information that's important to
us without having to save it in
a storage variable, which is
going to take up much more gas.
Each one of these events is tied
to the smart contract or account
address that emitted this event
in these transactions. listening
for these events is incredibly
helpful. Let's say for example,
you want to do something every
time somebody calls a transfer
function. Instead of always
reading all the variables and
looking for something to flip
and switch, all you have to do
is say, listen for event. So a
transaction happened, an event
is emitted. And we can listen
for these events. This is how a
lot of off chain infrastructure
works. When you're on a website,
and that website reloads when a
transaction completes, it
actually was listening for that
transaction to finish listening
for that event to be emitted, so
that it could reload or it could
do something else. It's
incredibly important for front
ends. It's also incredibly
important for things like chain
link, and the graph in the chain
link network. A chain link node
is actually listening for
request data events for to get a
random number, make an API call,
or etc. Sometimes there are way
too many events. And you need to
index them in a way that makes
sense that you can query all
these events that happen at a
later date. The graph listens
for these events and stores them
in the graph so that they're
easy to query later on. So
events are incredibly powerful.
And they have a wide range of
uses. They're also good for
testing and some other stuff,
but you get the picture. They're
really sick. Now that we know
what events are, let's look at
what they look like how we can
use them and how we might use
them in our smart contract
development suite. Now here's
what an event is going to look
like. We have an event here
called stored number. So we have
basically a new type of event
called stored number. We're
saying, hey, solidity, hey,
smart contract, we have this new
event thing, we're going to be
omitting things of typed stored
number in the future. When we
emit this event, it's going to
have these four parameters, it's
going to have a unique 256. For
called old number. Are you
interested? Is it called new
number are you intimidated six
called add a number and an
address called center. Now for
the astute people here, you
might have noticed that there
was another keyword in here, the
index to keyword and this is a
really important keyword. When
we omit one of these events,
there are two kinds of
parameters, there are the index
parameters and the non indexed
parameters, you can have up to
three index parameters. And
they're also known as topics. So
if you see a topic, you know
that that's going to be an
indexed parameter. Index
parameters are parameters that
are much easier to search for,
and much easier to query than
the non index parameters. In
fact, we recommend F get logs
function, it even has a
parameter allows us to search
for specific topics. So it's
much more searchable than the
non indexed ones. The non
indexed ones are harder to
search because they get ABI
encoded, and you have to know
the API in order to decode them.
Now, this is told our smart
contract that there is a new
type of stored number, a new
kind of event here, we need to
actually emit that event in
order to store that data into
the logging data structure of
the EVM. To do that, we need to
do something that looks like
this. This is what it looks like
when we emit an event, it looks
very similar to calling a
function. So you call a mitt and
then the name of the event. And
then you add all the parameters
in there that you like. Here's
the full example of a smart
contract that has an event and
is going to be the example that
we walked through in hard hat.
Now in this smart contract,
whenever anybody calls the store
function, we're going to omit
this event. Here's an example of
a transaction where we call the
store function with a value of
one, let's look into the logs to
see what this event actually is
going to look like an event is
going to be broken down like so
the address of the contract or
account, the event is emitted
from the topics or the index
parameters of the event data.
This is the ABI encoded non
index parameters of the event.
What does this mean? This means
that we took those parameters
that were non indexed, we match
them together with their API or
application binary interface,
pumped them through an encoding
algorithm, and boom, this is
what we got. If you have the
API, they're very easy to
decode. If you don't have the
ABI they are very hard to decode
these non indexed parameters
cost less gas to pump into the
logs. Now in this particular
contract, since we have verified
the code, we verified the
contract ether scan knows what
the ABI is, and we can view this
in Deke or decoded mode. Hex
mode is obviously the non
decoded mode, or in its raw, hex
or hexadecimal or encoded mode.
You can read more about the
layout of these events in the
solidity docs. Now, so that's
the basic introduction of
events. And for those of you who
want to watch the rest of that
video, and who wants to actually
practice using events yourself,
there's a link to these videos
and the code repository
associated with that video, if
you want to play with it, and if
you want to learn more, so feel
free Ready to refer back to the
full blockchain solidity course,
Jas, if you want to go deeper
into events now that we're back,
and we've learned a little bit
more about events, let's add
some events to this contract.
Remember, these events get
emitted to a data storage
outside of this smart contract.
Let's create an event called
raffle enter a good syntax for
naming events, name events, with
the function name reversed. So
for enter raffle, we're gonna
say raffle entered. So up at the
top below our state variables,
but above our constructor, we'll
create a new section called
events. And we'll create our
first event. So we'll do event,
raffle, Enter. And we'll just
have this raffle enter take one
index parameter, it'll be an
address indexed player. So in
our Inter raffle, we're going to
say omit raffle enter. And we're
just going to pass it message
dot sender. I'm going to remove
these comments for now. But feel
free to leave them in as you
code along. Now in this part of
my raffle coding or my lottery
coding process, I probably would
start already writing some tests
and already writing some deploy
scripts. The reason that we do
this is it's good to test our
functionality as we progress.
And oftentimes, when I'm writing
smart contracts, I'm constantly
flipping back and forth between
my deploy scripts, my contracts
and my tests to make sure
everything is doing exactly what
I want it to do for the purpose
of this course. And just to make
it easy for you to learn and
follow along, we're not going to
do that. And we're just going to
keep writing our smart contract
almost to complete and then move
to our deploy scripts and tests.
So in its minimalistic sense, we
essentially have a way for
people to enter our raffle. Now
we need a way to pick the random
winner. And this is where we're
going to need chain link VRF and
chain link keepers. So let's
again, watch some sub lessons
about learning about chain link
VRF. And learning about chain
link keepers. We've made some
videos about these before. So
we're just going to play these
videos. So you can learn about
how taling VRF version two
works, and also how chain link
keepers works, then we're going
to come back and we're going to
add them into our contracts
here. If you're already
familiar, and you already played
with them, feel free to skip
those sections. And we'll just
get to building them here.
Hi, my name is Steven fluid. And
today we're going to be taking a
look at chain links VRF. version
two, version two has a few
different mental models that we
should be aware of. And I want
to show you what it feels like
to be using it. The big
important thing to know about
Vera version two is that instead
of the Vera one model where
you'd be funding your contract
with Link, instead, you're going
to be funding a subscription,
which is basically an account
that allows you to fund and
maintain balance for multiple
consumer contracts. Let's dive
into the docs and see what using
Vera fie two looks and feels
like. In order to show this off
a little bit. I'm going to dive
right into the get a random
number guide in the chain link
documentation. And so it's going
to go through a few the
requirements of some of the
technology we're going to use
today. And the first thing it's
going to ask us to do is to make
sure that we are on the Rinkeby
test net. So let's go ahead and
jump over to Rinkeby. Make sure
my meta mask is unlocked here.
And now that I'm on Rinkeby,
great, I should be able to use
the VIP version to test net. Now
we're going to jump over to
subscription manager. And the
subscription manager is where
we're going to manage our
subscription account. Basically,
this is the place that you put
the funds in order to be able to
use it across a bunch of
different chains. So we're going
to go ahead and connect our
wallet here in order to use the
subscription app. And then we're
going to go ahead and create a
new subscription. So we'll just
use my address as the
subscription address here. I'll
approve the creation. And as
soon as that transaction is
confirmed, our subscription
should be created. Alright, now
we have a subscription.
Basically, this is the account
where we're going to fund it.
And then we can use that account
for all of our random Miss
requests. So I'm gonna go ahead
and just put in 10 link here,
you can put in however much you
want. The price and link of
every random number you request,
it's going to be based on the
current gas rates on a given
chain, as well as the gasoline
that you've chosen. On our funds
have been added, let's go ahead
and add a consumer contract. So
it's asking us for consumer
address, we don't actually have
a consumer address yet. So let's
go ahead and jump over to the
documentation and create a
contract that is going to
request a number. So if you
scroll down, you're going to see
this Vera fee to consumer that
soul contract that we can open
it in remix, let's just jump
right there. We're gonna notice
a few different things in this
contract at the top, we've got
some input. So now you've got
VRF, consumer base version two,
we've got an interface for the
VRF coordinator, and then also a
reference to the link token
interface. So all of those are
specified for you on the Rinkeby
network here in the example
code. And then you can refer to
the documentation for whatever
chain you're going to be
deploying to. And then you're
going to see a few new options
here. So the key hash option is
the way that you specify that
gasoline that was described in
the documentation. So depending
on the key hash you choose for
the given chain you're on the
gas limit will be set
differently for your random
number requests. So for example,
on a theory main net, we have a
200 way key hash 500 Wiki hash
and 1000 graykey hash. You can
also see in our contract Hear
that we have a callback estimate
that you're in charge of. So
depending on how much gas you're
willing to spend in the fulfill
random number, you should set
this value appropriately. Next
up is request confirmations. So
this was something in verify
would be one that you could not
control. But here now, depending
on the chain you're on,
depending on the request and the
type nature of the request you
want to make, you can actually
change this number. And then one
of the most important and useful
features that gives you a lot
more flexibility and control of
your VRF is you can actually
specify the number of random
numbers you want. And so you
specify the number words, and
then that will specify how many
random you went to 56 as you get
back from the network. All right
here in the constructor, we're
gonna see a address for the
coordinator and address for the
link token. And then you'll see
that the subscription ID is
going to be created as we deploy
the contract. And so I'm gonna
go ahead and get that. So if you
remember when we created the
subscription after we found it,
and we see this subscription ID,
and now when I deploy this, I'm
going to use that subscription
ID. And we've got two methods
that should look very familiar,
we've got fulfill randomness
method that takes in randomness
is going to be fulfilled by the
Bureau of Oracle, as well as you
got request random words, which
is how we're actually going to
initiate the request to the
Oracle. So I think we're
actually are already ready to go
ahead and deploy this. So let's
jump to the deploy screen here
and select the right contract,
which in our case, is your FB to
consumer. And I'm going to make
sure that I am on injected web
three so that we can actually
deploy to the Rinkeby network.
And I'm going to paste in the
subscription ID here. And I'm
going to deploy, let's go ahead
and pay for that transaction.
And as soon as that is confirmed
by the network will show up
here, and we'll be able to copy
this address, and then add that
as a consumer and authorize this
contract to use my subscription
account. So let's go ahead and
authorize this with them another
Metamask transaction.
Alright, we can have your
subscription, we can see how
much link we funded it with. And
we can see our consumer
contract. So now by doing this,
we've authorized our consumer
contract to make requests for
randomness. So let's go ahead
and make a request for
randomness here. So we're gonna
go back to our contract that we
deployed here. And we're just
gonna use the remix interface
here to keep things simple. And
I'm going to request some
randomness. So obviously, this
is going to use all of the
configuration that I specified
in my contract, just kind of
hard coded here. So we're gonna
get to words of random is here.
So we're gonna hit request
randomness, confirm the Rigby
transaction. And then as soon as
that transaction comes back, we
should notice that we actually
have a request. And then what
we'll be doing is we'll be
waiting for the Oracle to call
fulfill random words on our
contract. And then we'll be
storing all of those random
words in this s random words,
storage variable. Let's go ahead
and check to see if our random
numbers come back from the
Oracle. So I'll go in here into
random words. And let's request
the zeroeth item of the array
looks like we've got a random
number there. And because we
requested two random numbers, we
should also have an item in
index one. All right, we we've
got our randomness there. And if
we go back to the subscription
manager app, you're going to see
that there's actually an event
history item here, we'll see
that we spent about point three,
three link to get those two
random numbers, we've just taken
a journey to see what it looks
like and feels like to use Veera
version two,
now that we've learned a little
bit more about chainlink VRF, I
hope that you took some time to
go to doxa chain link and play
around with it a little bit so
that you understand what's
really going on, we're going to
use this sample contract in here
to create our function that's
going to pick our random winner.
This is an on chain contract
that coordinates with a
verifiably random chain link
node to give us a random number,
you could look at the code
directly on chain, or you can
come right to the chain link
GitHub and look at all the code
for how this is actually
happening provably and randomly.
And we'll have a link to this in
the GitHub repo associated with
this course. So we're going to
create our function here called
pick a random winner, this
function is going to be called
by the chain link keepers
network so that this can
automatically run without us
having to interact with it. And
actually, while we're updating
this, I want to add some some
stars here saying view slash
pure functions. Now our pick
random winner function, we're
actually not going to make
public we're going to make
external, external functions are
a little bit cheaper than public
functions. Because solidity
knows that our own contract can
call this, we're actually going
to change the name of this
function, as well, very soon,
but we'll get to that in a
little bit. So in order for us
to pick a random winner, we
actually have to do two things,
we first have to request the
random number. And then once we
get it, do something with it. So
chainlink VRF is a two
transaction process. And this is
actually intentional. Having
random numbers in two
transactions is actually also
much better than having it in
one. If it's just one
transaction, then people could
just brute force tries
simulating calling this
transaction and we'll learn how
to simulate calls soon simulate
calling these transactions to
see what they can manipulate to
make sure that they are the
winner. We want to make sure
that this is absolutely fair.
Nobody can manipulate our smart
contract into having them be the
winner of the lottery, this
function is actually going to
request it. And then in a second
func the random number is going
to be returned. And in the
transaction that we actually get
the random number from the chain
link network, that's when we're
going to actually send the money
to the winner. And if we go to
the chain link documentation,
the function that the chain link
node calls is this function
called fulfill random words,
this is going to be the
requesting one, which we could
even change this to request
random winner to make it more
clear, and then we'll make a
function fulfill random words.
And this is going to be an
internal override, which we'll
explain in a little bit, now
fulfill fulfill random words
basically means we're fulfilling
random numbers. The word comes
from a computer science
terminology, but you can
basically just think of this as
fulfill random numbers, because
we can get multiple random
numbers. Now in order to make
our raffle contract VRF a bowl,
we have to import the chain link
code, we can go back to the
documentation, and we're just
going to grab this bottom line
and we'll grab the top line in a
second. So we're going to do
import, I'm going to write it
out. But if you want to copy
paste, you can at chain link
slash contracts slash SRC slash
V 0.8, slash V RF, consumer
base, b two dot Sol. And since
we're importing at chainlink,
slash contracts, we're gonna
need to add that in by running
yarn, add dash dash dev at
chainlink slash contracts. And
now that we have this in here,
we should be able to import like
so. And we're going to need to
make our raffle VRF consumer
base double, we're gonna need to
inherit VRF consumer base go
into our node modules at chain
link src, V 08 VRF, consumer
base V two, it comes with this
function fulfill random words.
And you can see it's an internal
virtual function, virtual means
it's expecting to be
overwritten, the reason that
it's in the sphere of consumer
base V two is so that the VRF
coordinator, which we'll use in
a bit knows that it can call
this fulfill random words
function. And this is the
function that we're overriding.
So back in our raffle dot salt,
we're going to inherit it by
doing is VRF consumer base V
two. And now if we scroll down
to fulfill random words, we can
add in the input parameters
fulfilled pill random words,
which are going to be un 256,
Request ID and un 256, a memory
array random words. And if we
hit Save Our linter will now
notice, okay, this is what I'm
expecting, I'm expecting us to
override the Fill random words,
which takes these parameters.
Now if we look in our docs in
our constructor, we need to pass
the VRF consumer base V TOS
constructor and pass that VRF
coordinator. Again, this V RF
coordinator is the address of
the contract that does the
random number verification. So
right next to our constructor
will add the VRF consumer base V
to constructor and we need to
pass the VRF coordinator v2
address. So in our main
constructor, we'll add that as a
parameter as well. So we'll say
address
VRF core to Nate Torre v two,
and then we'll pass this as a
parameter for the VRF consumer
basically till now that we have
that we shouldn't see that
little underscore anymore. And
we should be able to run yarn
aren't had compiled. Awesome.
And we can see compiled two
files successfully and our code
is working great. Now something
that I often do is I actually
hate running yarn hard hat all
the time, because that's too
many keys for my little brain to
work with. I would prefer to
write as little keys as possible
hard hat also would like us to
write as little keys as
possible. So hard hat comes with
a shorthand and autocomplete
hard hat shorthand is an NPM
package that installs a globally
accessible binary called H H,
that runs the project's locally
installed hard hat and supports
shell auto completion for tasks.
So what we can do is we're going
to start with NPM, like this,
but we're gonna install it with
yarn, we're going to run yarn,
global, add hardhat shorthand.
And what this is going to do, we
can see here installed hard hat
shorthand with binaries H, H,
and Hardhead completion. Now
instead of running yarn,
Hardhead compile, which we can
still run, we can just run h h
compile, running h h is going to
be the same thing as if we had
just run the Hardhead command
for our local directory. So now
we need to actually have our
request random winner function
requests a random winner. So
let's go back to the
documentation. And we'll see how
to do that. We can look at this
function request random words
and see exactly how it works. On
the Vera of coordinator address.
We go ahead and call this
request random words function,
we're going to need to call this
function on the coordinator
contract to get the coordinator
contract. We're going to use the
Vera v2 coordinator interface
and the Vir of coordinator
address. So we're going to want
to keep track of those. We can
do that once again in Arkansas.
factor, we have the address
being passed to our Bureau of
consumer base. Let's also keep
it as a state variable for us.
First, let's get the interface
so we can interact with that
contract, we can import that
from chain link as well by doing
import at chain link slash
contracts, slash SRC slash fees
0.8, slash inter faces slash VRF
cord to mentor V to interface
dot Sol. And now that we import
this interface, same as we did
with price feeds, we can do VRF,
coordinator v2, interface VRF
coordinator. And then we can
save the sphere of coordinator
using the address so we can say
VRF coordinator equals this
address VRF coordinator veto.
And we're just going to wrap
that address around the
interface so that now we can
work with this VRF coordinator
contract. Now we're only going
to set our VRF coordinator one
time right in our constructor.
So what's the best thing that we
can do here, private, immutable,
you Gosh, darn. Right, let's do
private, immutable, you have
coordinator and we'll change the
name to I underscore the ref
coordinator so that we know that
your coordinator is indeed an
immutable variable. In order to
request the random word, we need
to give it a number of
parameters, I'm gonna go ahead
and copy this line into our
contract just so that we can
talk about exactly what's going
on with it. And we don't need
the AES Request ID. And instead
of coordinator we're going to do
I underscore fear of
coordinator. So we're going to
call request random words on
that VRF coordinator contract,
and we need to pass it the key
hash or the gasoline, I prefer
calling it the gas lane, we go
to the chain link, Doc's go to
contract addresses. And we
scroll down we can see different
gas lanes a different
configuration parameters for
different networks is key hash
is going to be the gasoline of
the key hash, which tells the
chain link node the maximum
price you're willing to pay for
your guests and way if for
example, gas prices skyrocket,
and it's going to cost you a ton
of money to get that random
number setting a ceiling, we'll
make it so that random number
doesn't come back. For us to
pick a gas lane, we're probably
going to want to have this gas
lane or this key hash stored
somewhere. So let's go ahead and
make that a parameter of our
constructor as well. And we'll
save that as a state variable.
So we'll do comma bytes 32,
gasoline or key hash or whatever
you want to call it. And then
we'll make a new state variable.
And we're only going to set this
once. So we'll make this a
private, immutable. I underscore
gasoline, and then we'll say
gasoline equals gasoline.
So now, we can just swap this
out, or I underscore gasoline.
Okay, what's next, we need a
subscription ID, the
subscription ID is going to be
the subscription that we need
for funding our requests.
There's actually a contract on
chain, which we can use to fund
any subscription for any of
these external data or external
computation bits. And in this
contract, there's a list of
these subscriptions for people
to make requests to. So we need
the ID of the subscription that
we're using to request our
random numbers and pay the link
Oracle gas, the subscription ID
is probably also going to be
something we're going to pass as
a parameter to our lottery. So
once again, let's scroll up to
our constructor, we'll add a new
parameter. And our subscription
ID actually doesn't need to be a
un 256, it can actually be a
little bit smaller with a un 64.
So we'll pass a un 64 sub
scription ID, we'll make a UNT
64. Since we're only going to
set this once we'll make this a
private, immutable. I underscore
sub scription ID down here and
we'll say I subscription ID
equals sub subscription ID.
Alright, awesome. So now we can
change this to our subscription
ID. Okay, what's next? Request
confirmations request
confirmations is a un 16, which
says how many confirmations the
chain link node should wait
before responding. So if you
make a request, and there's only
one block confirmation, maybe
you don't actually send it
because you don't you're afraid
of some type of blockchain
reorganization or something,
we're not going to worry too
much about this. And we're
actually just going to make this
a constant of three. So we're
not even going to have this be
per amortizable we're gonna have
this one be a constant. So we'll
say a you int 16 Private
constant request, confirmations
equals three, and we're using
the capslock and underscores for
our constant variables here. And
now we'll grab request
confirmations and stick it in
right here. What's next callback
gas limit callback gas limit is
going to be the limit for how
much gas to use for the callback
request your contracts fulfill
random words, this sets a limit
for how much computation are
fulfilled random words can be
this is a good way to protect
ourselves from spending way too
much gas. If, for example, we
accidentally code our contract
in a way where fulfill random
words is incredibly gas
expensive. It'll block the
random number from responding.
We are going to make this
parameter sizable because we
want to change it depending on
how we code our fulfill random
word. So in our constructor,
let's add one more, we'll add
you int 32. Since the size of
this is a un 32, callback, gas
limit, and we'll save the sub
top as a UNT 32, private,
immutable, I underscore call
back. Yes limit. And we'll save
this. I call back gas limit
equals call back Yes, limit. And
then we'll take this, and we'll
stick it here. All right, we got
one more number of words, this
is going to be how many random
numbers that we want to get, we
only want one. So we're gonna go
back up to the top, we're going
to create a you int 32. And
we'll make this also a private
constant. Num words equals one,
because we only want one random
number. And then that'll be the
last thing we need to add for
our IVF coordinator dot request
random words. Now this request
random words function returns a
request ID a un 256 Request ID a
unique ID that defines who's
requesting this and all this
other information. If we want to
save it, we can do u and 256.
Request ID IVF coordinator
requests random words. Now for
now, we are going to emit an
event with this request ID. And
we'll go over why we're going to
do that a little bit later,
create a new event at the top.
And we're not going to follow
the naming convention here.
Because we're going to change
the name of our functions a
little bit, we're going to call
this requested raffle winner.
And we're going to take a un 256
indexed Request ID. Down here,
we're gonna do omit requested
raffle winner Request ID. And
now we have a function that we
can use to request a random
winner using chain link VRF. Now
again, we're going to set this
up so that the chain link
keepers call this on an
interval, but we'll do that in a
little bit. For now, let's
figure out what to do once we
get that
random number. Once we get that
random number, we're going to
want to pick a random winner
from our array of players up
here. So what do we do? Well,
let's go in here. And let's pick
a random winner using something
called the module function. Now
we're gonna get an array back of
random words, or random numbers,
if you will, since we're only
requesting one random word, this
random words array is going to
be of size one with one random
word in it. Now this random word
is a un 256. So this random word
could be something like this.
Well, obviously without the
hyphens, but it could be
something absolutely massive
like that our players array is
only going to be so big. So how
do we get a random winner from
this potentially massive random
number, we can use something
called the modulo function, the
module operation, a mod N
yields, the remainder are after
the division of an operand a by
the blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. So what does this mean?
Well, we can use the mod
function to get a random number
out of our players array. So
let's say our players array or
excuse me, our s players array
is of size 10. And a random
number is 200. So how do we pick
a random person out of this
players array, or, let's say our
random number is 202. If we do
202, which is our random number,
mod 10, we're gonna basically do
202 divided by 10. But instead
of having the decimals, we're
just going to say, Okay, how
many times is 10 evenly divide
into 202. And what's the
remainder, what doesn't divide
evenly into 202? Well, 20 times
10 equals 200, with two
leftover, so two doesn't evenly
divide, or multiply into 200. So
that means 202 mod 10 is going
to equal to two. So that's how
the module function works. And
we can use that so we're always
going to get a number between.
So we're always going to get a
number here between zero and
nine, which works out perfectly
because that which works out
perfectly, because those are the
indexes of the 10 people in our
array. So let's use that here.
We'll say a un 256 index of
winner is going to be equal to
random words, at index zero,
because we're only getting one
random word module, the S
underscore players dot length.
So this will give us the index
of our random winner to get that
address of the winner will do
address payable, recent winner
equals s players at this index
of winner so awesome. So now
we'll have the address of the
person that got this random
number, the person's that's
going to be our verifiably
random winner. Now, it might be
kind of cool to brag to people
that you're the recent winner.
So let's go ahead to the top and
we'll create a new state
variable for our most recent
winner make this state variable
in a new section called lottery
variables. We'll say address
private s underscore recent
winner and it'll start out as
nobody but as we get winners
update it with s recent winner
equals recent winner and we'll
probably want people to know who
this is winter is so down below,
we can do function get recent
winner, it's going to be a
public view that's going to
return that address. And then
we'll just say return s
underscore recent winner, since
again, the recent winner is
going to be a storage variable.
So now that we have a recent
winner, what else are we gonna
do? Well, we're probably going
to want to send them the money
in this contract. So we're going
to do exactly what we did before
with sending the money, we're
going to do that bull success,
comma, blank equals recent
winner, call, I'm gonna say
value, it's going to be address
of this dot balance, we're going
to send all the money in this
contract, and we're going to
pass it no data. And now we
could say require, you know,
success, whatever, we're going
to be a little bit more gas
efficient here. And we're just
gonna say, if not success, then
we're going to revert a new
transfer failed error. So we're
gonna go to the top, or say,
error name of the contract is
raffle, underscore, underscore,
transfer failed, like that, then
go back down, and we can now do
revert, raffle transfer failed
like that. And now that we've
picked a winner, right now, we
don't have a way to actually
keep track of the list of
previous winners. So we're just
going to omit an event. So
there's always going to be that
easily query double history of
event winners. So we're going to
create a new event in the events
section called the event winner
picked. And this is going to be
an address indexed winner. And
we'll scroll down and we'll do
MIT winner picked the address of
the recent winner. This looks
pretty good.
This looks pretty good here. Now
you'll notice our request ID as
this little underscore here and
saying, hey, it's an unused
function parameter, since we
don't use this, but we still
need fulfill random words to
take a request ID and a random
words array. But we don't use
Request ID, we can just comment
out just the request ID part
like this, this tells our
function, hey, yes, we know that
you need a un 256. But we're not
going to use the request ID. So
we'll leave it in here. But
we'll leave it blank. Now let's
run a little compile here. We'll
use yarn, hard hat, compile, or
hh compile, we'll see if we're
coding things correctly. And
indeed, we don't see any errors.
So perfect, we can continue. So
we've added the chain link VRF,
where we have a way to
verifiably get a random winner.
This is fantastic. Now let's
update this contract so that not
only can it pick a verifiable
winner, but it can also do this
all programmatically and
automatically trigger picking a
random winner based off of some
time interval without us having
to interact with it. And in a
decentralized context. In order
for us to automatically trigger
smart contracts based off of
some parameter be a time
parameter, maybe the price of
some asset is some number, maybe
there's a certain amount of
money in the liquidity pool or
really whatever trigger that you
want, we can use chain link
keepers. To do this. Steven
fluid has done once again, an
amazing introduction to chain
the keepers. So we're going to
follow along with another sub
video section of Steven
explaining chain link keeper
sauce, he's going to be using
the COVID test net, but be sure
to use whatever test net is in
the documentation. When you play
with this and you try this.
My name is Steven foon. Today, I
want to show you how to use the
chain link keeper network in
order to automate your contracts
and give them access to off
chain computation. Let's go
ahead and dive in. So what we're
going to look at today is we're
going to start on the chain link
documentation webpage. And if
you just scroll down a little
bit, you're going to find using
chain link keepers. Now there's
really two parts to building a
chain link keeper up kept smart
contract. So the first thing is
you need to write a smart
contract that's compatible by
implementing these two methods.
And then second, you want to
register that smart contract for
upkeep with the channeling
keeper network. So let's go
ahead and do both of those
things. So let's start off just
by copying and deploying this
sample code that we've got. With
this one click to remix, what
we're gonna see here is a very,
very simple contract. That is
just a simple counter. So we can
see it's got a counter here. So
it's got just a simple number.
And then you're able to specify
when you create the contract and
update interval, and then the
contract is going to verify Hey,
has enough time passed. And if
it has, let's update the
counter. And you're going to
notice that chinley compatible
or timekeeper network compatible
contracts use two really
important methods that are part
of this keeper compatible
interface. The first is check
upkeep, and check upkeep is
special because this is where
the off chain computation
happens. So this is a method
that's not actually run on
chain. This is run off chain by
a node from the channeling
keeper network. And so what's
really nice about this is that
the gas used here isn't actually
gas, it's on chains. This is
just being run by a chain link
node. And then what happens is
if your check upkeep method
returns, the upkeep is needed.
Then it's going to go ahead and
perform upkeep. On chain, so you
can actually generate data off
chain, and then pass that in.
That's called the check data.
And then that becomes the
performed data that's passed
into perform upkeep. And so the
PErforM upkeep method is where
you're going to want to verify
that things are correct. And
that things actually should be
modified and run on chain, and
then actually make the state
change. And so let's go ahead
and compile this contract and
deploy it to the COVID network.
So let's go ahead and within
remix, we can do this
compilation. And we're going to
compile and deploy directly to
COVID. So the zookeeper network
is currently as of the filming
of this, available on both COVID
as well as the theory of main
net. And let's go ahead and play
the counter contract. And let's
see what's not updating more
than every 30 seconds. And so
let's go ahead and deploy. So
meta masks can ask for a little
bit of payment, in order for me
to deploy this contract to the
COVID network. And it looks like
that is live. So now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to be
able to take this keeper
contract, and copy its address.
And now we're going to register
that contract for upkeep. So
we're going to jump over to the
application that powers the
champion keeper network, there's
a few different ways you can
use, you can interact directly
with the registry contract. But
there's a very, very nice
interface that lets you do this.
So let's go ahead and register a
new upkeep and it's giving me an
error that says you need to
connect your wallet. So let's go
ahead and do that. So I'm going
to just connect wallet here, and
I'm gonna give it access to my
account. And then from there, we
should actually be able to
register. So I'm going to use an
email address here. I'll give my
contract a simple name. I'll
paste in that address from the
deployed contract, and then I'll
give it a gas limit. And then
check data is this special thing
where you can actually register
multiple upkeeps On the same
contract in passing data to
specify how you want checkup
keep to be run of, we're just
going to ignore that that is an
optional one. And then we'll
give it a starting balance of
around 10 link, it's gonna go
ahead and use Metamask again to
register that transaction on the
network. And once it's
confirmed, my upkeep should be
registered with the network and
funded with 10 Link To kick
things off. Alright, if we go
ahead and view the upkeep, we
can see it's registered. And as
soon as the next round of the
keeper nodes executes, which
should be roughly about every
block, we should see that the
check upkeep method is going to
return that hey, upkeep is
actually needed because the
timestamp is more than 30
seconds ago. And then we should
go ahead and perform upkeep. So
as soon as I take a look at this
in remix, I can actually make
this bigger here, we're going to
be able to see from the methods
of the contract, if we check the
counter, it's going to start at
zero. And as soon as that 30
seconds has passed, we'll be
able to hit the counter again,
we'll see that the channeling
keeper network has performed
upkeep on my contract. Alright,
we just refresh and we see the
balance of the upkeep has been
decreased by about point 01
link. And we should also see
within our contract that our
counter has now updated via
proof that perform upkeep method
call. And now our counter is at
one showing us that our contract
is being approved by the
chainlink keeper network. And
everything is working exactly as
we expect. So as you can see, it
is very, very easy to create a
contract that is compatible with
the keeper network. And it's
very easy to register that
upkeep and start seeing that
your contract automation and
option computation are working
flawlessly.
Now that we've learned a little
bit more about how chainlink
keepers work if you want to take
some time to go through the
documentation and open up way
down below this open and remix
button. So you can actually work
with one of these and see these
in action for yourself on a test
net, feel free to do so we're
gonna be using a setup very
similar to this keepers counter
setup in the chain link
documentation. So now let's
update our code so that this
request random numbers
automatically happens using
chain link keepers. And if we
look at the example contract can
actually read more about what's
really important for this to
work. And we need a check upkeep
and a perform upkeep function in
our code. So instead of request
random winner, this is going to
be the PErforM upkeep that we're
going to change. But first let's
make this check upkeep checkup
keep function is basically going
to be checking to see is it time
for us to get a random number to
update the recent winner and to
send them all the funds. So
let's go ahead and make that
function. I'm going to add some
notes here, just so that it's
clear what's going on. And maybe
I'll even do natspec To tell
developers what's going on with
this function. So we're going to
create this function check
upkeep. And if we look at what
this needs, it needs to be
external override external
override. And if we see this
override keyword, this means
that okay, there's probably a
perform upkeep somewhere else.
And if we scroll to the top, and
we're going to import this
keeper compatible interface, so
that we make sure that we
implement both check upkeep and
perform upkeep in our code here.
If you want you can just import
keeper compatible in here or
just the keeper compatible
interface in our code. We're
going to do import at chain link
slash contracts slash SRC slash
V 0.8 point two interfaces slash
keeper compatible interface that
soul and now we're just gonna
say contract raffle is Veera of
consumer base V two and keeper
compatible interface and this
keeper compatible interface
inheritance just make sure that
we add checkup keep and perform
upkeep, which we're going to add
in a little bit. And if we look
back at the docs we can see
checkup keep takes a bytes
called Data check data as an
input parameter. So we'll do
bytes called data. Check data as
a parameter. Now this check
upkeep bytes call data allows us
to specify really anything that
we want when we call this check
upkeep function. Having this
check data be of type bytes
means that we can even specify
this to call other functions,
there's a lot of advanced things
you can do by just having an
input parameter as type of bytes
for us though, we're going to
keep it a little bit simple. And
we're actually not going to use
this check data piece. So
similar to how below we're not
using Request ID, we can just
comment it out. However, we
still need to make sure that
this parameter is type of bytes
called data. Now anyways, let's
go ahead and annotate this check
upkeep function, we'll say this
is the function that the chain
link keeper nodes call they look
for the to return true. Look
back at the documentation, we
can see that this check upkeep
returns both and upkeep needed
and to perform data, which
again, we're going to ignore
this upkeep needed is going to
be true or false. If it's true,
that means it's time to get a
new random number following
should be true in order to
return true. So in order for it
to be time to request a random
winner, what should happen, our
time interval should have
passed, which we haven't defined
yet. But we will lottery should
have at least one player and
have some eath. And then our
subscription is funded with Link
similar to how with channeling
Vir f your subscription needs to
be funded with Link, the same
thing needs to happen for check
upkeep and keepers to run your
subscription needs to be funded
with link. Now we're going to
add one more additional piece
here, we're going to say for the
lottery should be in an open
state, something that we want to
avoid when we're waiting for a
random number to return. And
when we've requested a random
winner. We're technically in
this weird limbo state where
we're waiting for a random
number to be returned. And we
really shouldn't allow any new
players to join. So what we
actually want to do is create
some state variable telling us
whether the lottery is open or
not. And while we're waiting for
our random number to get back,
we'll be in a closed or a
calculating state.
Now what we could do at the top
of our contract, we can just say
Boolean, private, s underscore
is open. And we can just set
this to true if we're open
otherwise false. Well, what if
we have a ton of different
states? What if we want it to be
like pending, open, closed,
calculating, etc? What do we
have a ton of different states?
Well, we could make this a U and
256. Private s underscore state.
And we could just keep track of
the state having like zero b
pending a one reopen to be
closed, three, be calculating,
etc. But this can be a little
tricky to keep track of. So a
better way to actually keep
track of all this in our code is
to use an enum enums, can be
used to create custom types with
a finite set of constant values.
So we can create, for example, a
state created locked inactive,
and it's basically a new type
for a smart contract for us,
we're going to create a new
type. And if we go back to the
layout of variables, and our
smart contract types should
actually be first thing in our
contract. So we're going to
create an E new called raffle
state. And for now, and we're
just going to have it be open,
we're just gonna have to be open
or calculating. Now when we
create an enum like this, we're
kind of secretly creating a un
256, where zero equals open, and
one equals calculating. However,
this is much more explicit that
we know what each one of these
numbers actually means. Now that
we've created this new type
called raffle state, we can
create a new lottery state
variable of type raffle state.
So the exact same way we declare
any other variable, we'll name
its type, which is going to be
raffle state. And this is going
to be a storage variable. So
we'll go ahead and do private s
underscore raffle state in our
constructor, right when we
launched this contract, we
should open up this raffle. So
we'll say s, raffle state equals
and we could use a un 256.
Wrapped in type raffle state
like so. Or we can be more
explicit and say raffle state
DOT open. Now we know that the
raffle state is in an open state
and we only want checkup keep to
work is if the lottery is
actually open. Additionally, we
probably only want people to be
able to enter if the law
battery's open. So let's go
ahead and create another if
statement and revert if the
lottery isn't open. So we can
say if s underscore raffle state
does not equal raffle state DOT
open, then we're going to revert
with a new error, we're going to
create raffle underscore
underscore, not open. And of
course, at the top will create
error, raffle not open. Now
additionally, let's go down when
we're requesting a random word.
Let's update the state to be
calculating so other people
can't jump in here. So right
above our VRF coordinator dot
request, random words will do s
underscore raffle state equals
raffle state DOT calculating so
that nobody can enter our
lottery and nobody can trigger a
new update. And then once we
fulfill after we pick our
winner, we'll say s raffle state
equals raffle state DOT open
again. Something else that we
forgot to do was after we pick a
winner from s players, we need
to reset our players array. So
let's add that in here as well
as players equals new address
payable. array of size zero. So
we'll reset the raffle state.
And we'll reset our players
array. Alright, great. So now
that we've learned about enum,
let's add it to our checkup keep
here, we're going to check these
four things. And if they all
pass checkup keys will be true
and will trigger the chain the
keepers to request a new random
winner. So first, we'll say bool
is open. It's going to be equal
to raffle state. That open
equals equals s underscore
raffle state. So you can think
of that as this boolean is open
is going to be true if raffle
state is in an open state, and
it will be false if raffle state
is in any other state. So great.
We haven't is open Boolean that
we can check later on. What else
do we need? Well, we need to
check to make sure our time
interval is past well, we don't
have a time interval yet. So
let's create a time interval. In
order to check the time we can
use another one a solidity is
globally available variables
with block dot timestamp block
that timestamp returns the
current timestamp of the
blockchain to get the current
timestamp, we're gonna need
block dot timestamp. But to get
if enough time has passed, we're
going to need to get the current
block dot timestamp minus the
last block timestamp, which we
don't have yet. Let's go ahead
and create a state variable to
keep track of the previous block
timestamp. So this is going to
be a new state variable that
we're going to make. I'm gonna
say u and 256. Private s
underscore last timestamp.
And right when we deploy this
contract, we'll update this with
the current timestamp s last
timestamp equals block dot
timestamp. Alright, awesome. Now
we have a last block timestamp.
But we're going to need to check
that the difference between the
current timestamp and the last
timestamp is greater than some
interval. So we also need to
create an interval. And this is
going to be some interval, this
is going to be some number in
seconds of how long we want to
wait between lottery runs. So
let's go ahead and add this to
our constructor as well. And do
a comma here. And we'll do u and
256. Interval. And we're going
to create another global
variable u and 256 Private s
underscore interval. And in our
constructor and we'll say s
interval equals interval. Now
interval isn't going to change
after we set it. So instead of
making a storage variable, let's
make it an immutable variable to
save some gas. Okay, perfect.
Now that we have all this, I'm
actually create a boolean to
check to see if enough time has
passed. So we'll say Boolean
time passed equals the current
block that timestamp minus s
underscore last timestamp. And
we should check to see that this
is actually greater than I
underscore interval. So we have
a Boolean check to see if we're
open. It'll be true if we're
open and we'll have a boolean to
see if enough time has passed.
This will be true if enough time
has passed. What else should we
check? While we should check to
see if we have enough players.
So we'll do Boolean has players
equals and we'll check to see if
s underscore players dot length
is greater than zero. If s
players dot length is greater
than zero as players will be
true, otherwise it'll be false.
And we'll also see if we have a
balance so we'll do Boolean has
balance equals address. This dot
balance is greater than zero.
Then finally, we're going to
take all these booleans and turn
them into the return variable
that we're looking for. We're
gonna say Boolean up keep
needed. Equals is open and time
passed. And as players and as
balance, like that, so all these
combined is gonna be this
Boolean upkeep needed. And if
this returns true, it's time to
request a new random number and
it's time to end the lottery. If
this is false, it's not time
yet, it's not time to end the
lottery up. Now again, if we go
to the chainlink, documentation
upkeep needed, actually needs to
return that Boolean upkeep
needed and some bytes memory
perform data. So we need to
update we need to update our
function here. And say returns
full upkeep needed, comma, bytes
memory, perform data star slash.
And since we've initialized
Boolean up, keep needed up here,
we don't need to say what type
of upkeep needed is down here.
Since this will automatically
get returned performed data is
something that we can use. If we
want to have checkup, keep do
some other stuff. Depending on
how this checkup keep went. We
don't really need it to do
anything else. So we can just
leave it as such. Right. So now
we have a check upkeep, we have
a way to check to see if it's
time to trigger picking our
random winner of our lottery
or our raffle. Now that we
learned how to actually do this
trigger, let's write the
function that gets executed
after this returns true. This is
going to be our perform upkeep
function, which we can see an
example again in the chainlink
documentation. Now when it's
time to pick a random winner,
actually, what we're going to do
is just we're just going to call
this request random winner
function. So instead of having
this extra function, let's just
transform our request random
winner function into this
perform upkeep. Since once check
upkeep returns true, the chain
link nodes will automatically
call this perform upkeep
function. So in function request
random winner, let's rename this
to perform upkeep. And we'll
have it take the input parameter
bytes called Data perform data
bytes, called data, perform
data. In our checkup, keep we
had to perform data, we would
automatically pass it to our
performance keep, we're not
going to pass anything to
perform upkeep, we can leave it
commented out like this. Since
perform upkeep is actually
identified in the keeper
compatible interface, this is
now going to have to override
that function. Now we want to do
a little bit of validation
before we continue here. Because
right now anybody can call our
perform upkeep function. So we
want to make sure that it only
gets called when checkup keep is
true. An easy way for us to do
that is to actually call our own
checkup, keep function. Now
right now, checkup keep it's an
external. So we actually can't
call our own checkup keep
function. So let's change it to
public so that even our own
smart contracts can call this
checkup keep function. Now that
we've made it public in perform
upkeep, we can call checkup,
keep passing nothing, and then
return the upkeep needed and
perform data which we don't
really care about. So we'll get
we'll get that ball up keep
needed. And then we don't care
about perform data. So we'll
leave that blank equals check up
keep. And we'll pass it a blank
called data. Now, we want to
make sure that this is true in
order to keep going with the
function. So we could write a
require here, but we're going to
do if not up keep needed, then
we're going to revert with a new
error that we create raffle.
upkeep not needed. And we're
going to pass some variables to
this error
so that whoever was running into
this bug can hopefully see why
they're getting this error. So
we'll pass the balance of this
contract just in case there's no
ether in here. We'll add the
players dot length, just in case
there's no players. And we'll
add a un 256 s underscore raffle
state. Make sure that the
raffles actually open. And then
of course, we'll need to create
this air at the top air, raffle
upkeep not needed, which is
going to take a un 256 current
balance un 256 non players and
you went to fit six raffle
state. Our code is starting to
look really professional. This
is awesome. Now something that
we forgot to do back in the
fulfill random words because we
actually forgot to reset
timestamp every time a winner is
picked. We want to reset the
timestamp as well so that we can
wait another interval and let
people participate in the
lottery for that interval. So
we'll scroll down into fulfill
random words. And right after we
reset players will also reset
the timestamp. Okay great and I
think we're just about done
here. Let's add a little bit of
natspec to make this look even
more professional and and give
people who are reading our
contract even more information.
So let's add title here at title
and we'll say a sample raffle
contract will say an author is
going to be me Patrick Collins
or you can put your own name
there as well at notice. This
contract is for creating and
untampered orrible decentralized
smart contract. And then we'll
do add Dev, this implements
chain link VRF v two, and chain
link keepers. Alright, awesome.
We've got our type declarations,
we've got our state variables,
we've got lottery variables,
which are still state variables,
we've got our events. Now it's
time for our functions.
Afterwards, we've done a little
bit of natspec, at least on our
check upkeep. If you want to add
some more natspec on things like
enter, raffle, perform upkeep,
etc, you can absolutely do so.
And then down at the bottom, we
have our views slash pure getter
functions. Let's see, do we want
any other getter functions here?
Well, we probably want to give
people the chance to get a
raffle state. So we'll do
function, get raffle state, this
will be a public, you returns a
raffle state. We'll say return s
underscore raffle state, we
probably want to give people the
chance to get the number of
words. And this is going to be a
little bit interesting here
running. So if we do function,
get num words, public view
returns, you went to the six
return num words, you'll see
something interesting happened
here. We pull up our compiler
and run hh compile. Hopefully
everything works here. Oh, and
everything doesn't work because
I didn't import this correctly.
Let's fix that. Let's try again.
Oh, there's a couple things I
missed. Let's fix es players.
This is why it's good to compile
as you code as players dot
length. Let's try again. And I
spelt interval wrong. I
underscore inter vol strike to
compile again, see how many more
spelling mistakes I made. And
there it is. I underscore in
error go to paste that and we do
get another error here. Invalid
type for argument in a function
call invalid implicit conversion
from literal string to bytes
called data requested. Since
we're passing this empty string
here. And checkup keep needs a
call data called data actually
doesn't work with strings. So we
need to make this bytes memory
instead. And our compiler is now
happy with us. And I spell it
the timestamp wrong. That's a
lowercase s so and you might see
some squiggles here on Check
upkeep, we could make this a
view function since we're not
actually modifying any state.
But I want to keep it public for
reasons I'll show you a little
bit later. But finally we get
the the yellow squiggly that I
was looking for here. And if we
run hh compile, we should see a
warning in our compiler as well.
Okay, so we see all those yellow
squigglies here. Unnamed return
variable can remain unassigned.
We need this bytes memory in
here because that's what the
keepers are looking for. Morning
function state mutability can be
restricted to view for our
function checkup key. You can
make a view if you want, but I'm
going to keep it public for
reasons I'll show you a little
bit later. And finally, function
state mutability can be
restricted to pure this is what
I wanted to show you since num
words is actually in the
bytecode, since it's a constant
variable technically isn't
reading from storage, and
therefore this can be a pure
function. Returning num words
doesn't actually read in
storage, it literally will go
and read the number one. So
doing get num words in solidity
with num words being a constant
variable, it's going to
literally be the exact same as
saying get one and we would
return one here, we might also
want to get the number of
players. So we'll create a
function get number of players.
And this will be a public view,
returns a un 256. Turn s
underscore players dot length.
We're also probably going to
want the latest timestamp. So
we'll do function get latest
timestamp. public view returns
you in 256. And we're just going
to return s underscore last
timestamp. And maybe we'll want
to do request confirmation. So
we'll do function GET request
confirmations. Public pure since
request confirmations is also a
constant function returns you
went to you went to 56 Turn
request confirmations. All
right, we've got some wonderful
getters here. Some views slash
pure functions, we have a way to
get a random number we have a
way in a decentralized context.
Automatic automatically execute.
picking a random winner we have
a way for people to enter our
raffle to enter this lottery.
And we have a bullet proof way
to solve creating a truly fair
decentralized lottery. Oh my
goodness. Let's do one more
compile for good measure H H
compile. And these are just
warnings. So we're good to go
here. Our code is compiling
successfully. Like I said
Normally, this definitely isn't
going to be the way that you're
going to write your smart
contracts, it's almost
impossible to write a full smart
contract without making any
mistakes. And without flipping
back and forth between
documentation, I have already
written this contract many times
myself, and I still made a whole
bunch of mistakes. So it is
totally reasonable and totally
rational for anybody and
everybody to make mistakes going
through this. And to use
resources and to write tests
along the way. Now that we have
our raffle dot Seoul created,
it's time to add everything
else. So we're going to come
over here, we're gonna create a
new folder, and add our deploy
folder per usual.
And we're going to do exactly
what we've already done a couple
of times, we're going to create
some scripts to deploy our
raffle contract. Now with our
raffle contract, there's a
couple of things in here that we
want to make note of first thing
is that our constructor right
now is absolutely massive. There
are a ton of parameters in here
that we need to account for.
Let's take a look at our
constructors and see if there's
any contracts that we're already
interacting with. Okay, VRF,
coordinator v2. This is a
contract address, entrance fee,
no gasline, no subscription ID
no callback, guestimate No, and
interval. No. So knowing that
this is an address should be a
tip that Ah, okay, we're
probably going to need to deploy
some mocks. For this, since
we're going to need to interact
with a VRF coordinator contract
that's outside of our project.
But let's go ahead and start
working on our raffle deployment
script first, and we know we're
going to have to deploy some
mocks. So we'll just keep that
in mind. So let's create a new
file. Oh, one, deploy raffle.js.
And let's get started deploying
our raffle contract. Now, this
is going to look really similar
to what we've done before. And
we're going to do it again here.
If you want to use your previous
deploy scripts as a reference, I
absolutely recommend you do so.
But let's get started with
module that exports equals an
async function. That's going to
take get named accounts and
deployments. As input
parameters, then we're going to
do const. Deploy log equals
deployments, then we're gonna
say const, Deployer, equals
await, get named accounts. Let's
go to our config and update
module that exports to to have
this I'm just going to copy
paste, so that employer is going
to be defaulted to account zero
and player is going to be
defaulted to account one, if you
want to go ahead and write this
out, feel free to pause and
write out your name accounts.
Right now, there's gonna be a
lot of boilerplate in our heart
hat.config.js. So feel free to
have the GitHub repo for this
lesson up with you or your
previous scripts that you've
already written as a reference
named accounts Deployer. And
we're also going to have a
player named account so that we
can separate different users or
different players who are
interacting with our contracts.
But for now, we're gonna grab
our Deployer. And we're gonna
get started. Now similar to last
time, we would just do const,
raffle equals await ploy,
raffle, comma, and then add all
of our stuff in here, right? So
this would be from Deployer.
args, we're going to have a ton
of args. So we're going to come
back to this. And then log is
going to be true. And then we're
going to have wait
confirmations, there's a little
bit more boilerplate we need to
work with here in our Hardhead
config, we don't have a network
here. So let's add our network
information. So we can get those
block confirmations will be
specific in here, as well. And
we'll say default network is
going to be hard hat. And then
we'll say
networks, and we'll add our
network information that's going
to be working with heart hub,
which has a chain ID of 31337
miles, we'll put that in here as
well. And block confirmations
were just set to one lot this
column here, we're also gonna be
running some staging tests on
the Rinkeby network. So we'll
add rink B in here with a chain
ID of four, block confirmations
of six, and we need to add a URL
and then also some accounts for
our URL. We've done this 100
times. We'll do const. rinky
dink could be RPC URL equals
process study and v dot rake,
the RPC URL, that's private key,
blah, blah, blah, we're going to
add all these same variables
from our last projects. So I'm
going to ask you to pause here
and just copy paste all those
variables from our last project.
Boom, like so since running
rink, prpc, URL, private key
corn market cap and ether scan,
we're also going to want to make
sure you folder, excuse me, new
file, dot env. And we're going
to drop all of our information
in here our rink, prpc, URL,
private key, ether scan API key,
and then our coin market cap API
key as well. Now that we have
our private key or ring prpc URL
down in URL, B RPC URL, and for
accounts, we're just going to
add that single private key. Now
for weight confirmations is
going to equal For network
config dot block con formations,
or one, we're gonna have to
import network from Hardhead,
which looks like my VS code
automatically did for me. Thanks
VS code. So this is how we're
going to deploy a raffle.
Obviously, we have a ton of
arguments that we need to
account for. So let's get to it.
Let's look at our raffle
constructor to see what we need
to get. Okay, well, the first
thing that we need to get via of
coordinator v2, we're gonna use
the same strategy we used in our
Funmi project with using mocks,
if we're on a development chain,
and using the actual contract
address if we're on a test net,
or a live network, so let's get
to it. So let's go ahead,
recreate that helper, hard hat
config dot j s and create that
const. Network. Config, say it
equals for hard hat, we're going
to use a mock. So we don't need
to put that in here for now. But
for rink B, let's go ahead, but
a foreign here, so the name is
going to be Rinkeby. And we're
going to need to go to the chain
link documentation, the VRF
contracts, and we're going to
need to grab the RF coordinator
for the Rinkeby. Test net, we're
going to grab this address here,
plop it in here, we'll say V RF
core did an eight tour v two,
bam, right like that. So back in
our deploy raffle, we're gonna
have to pick whether or not to
use the V RF coordinator v two
in the network config or some
mock that we deployed, which of
course, leads us to us having to
deploy a mock, let's create the
new file 00. Deploy marks.js. So
same thing module that exports
equals async function where it's
taking, get named accounts, and
deployments, as its input
variables from the heart at
runtime environment, or do const
deploy COMM A log equals
deployments. And then const,
Deployer equals await, get named
accounts, Excel, and then we're
going to grab the chain ID as
well as we're going to only
wants to deploy this on a
development chain. So we'll do
const chain ID equals network
dot config dot chain ID. Now
we're going to only want to
deploy mocks, if we're on a
development chain. So once
again, we're going to go to our
helper config, we're going to
add those development chains in
here. We'll say const,
development chains equals hard
hat, and localhost. And then
we're gonna want to export both
of these. So module, dot
exports, equals network config,
and development chance. Now in
our deploy mocks, we're gonna
want to grab those are saying
const development chains, equals
require dot dot slash helper
helper hardhat config. Now we
can check to see if development
chains dot includes the network
dot name that we're currently
on. If we're in a development
chain, we're gonna go ahead and
log local network, the
protected, deploying box. And
now we'll have to deploy a mock
VRF coordinator, where do we get
a mock VRF to coordinator Well,
let's go ahead and create one of
those.
We go to the chainlink. GitHub
again, we go to contracts. So C
0.8, actually have a mocks
folder with VF coordinator v2
Mach dot Sol, and we're just
going to use this as our mock.
So in our contracts folder,
we're gonna create a new file
called test new file called V RF
core, in a core, the two mock
dot Sol, and we're just going to
import this mock and have it be
our mock. So we'll do spdx.
We'll do pragma, solidity,
carrot zero, point 8.0, or seven
or whatever we want to do, we'll
do import at chainlink slash
contracts slash SRC slash v 0.8.
Slash, mocks, slash VRF. Pour
did a tour B to mock that soul.
And we'll just check to see if
it compiles with Hardhead
compile, and it looks like it's
compiling as well. Awesome. So
now that we have our mock
contract, we can actually go
ahead and deploy it. So we'll do
a weight loi, the RF core de ne
Tor V to Mach
comma, and then we'll give it
our parameters in here. We'll
say from Deployer. Log is going
to be true, and then we're going
to do our arguments. Now, what
are the arguments of this VRF
coordinator, v2 Mk. Well, if we
open the VRF coordinator v2
Mock, right in our VS code, or
on GitHub, we can actually see
We will roll over to the
constructor that it takes two
things. It takes a base fee and
a gas price link. What are these
first one? Well, the first one
is this const base fee. If we go
back to the documentation, we
can see that there's this
premium section of 0.25 Link
rink B, this means that for each
request, there's a base fee of
0.25 link for every request. So
anytime we want to request a
random number on Rinckey, it's
going to cost us 0.25. Link, or
you can think of it as 0.25
Oracle gas to make this request.
So back in our deploy mocks, we
can say base V equals, we could
resemble Rinckey here and do 25,
blah, blah, blah, or we could do
ethers dot utils dot parse eath,
of 0.25. And I'll even put a
little comment here, say 0.25 is
the premium, it costs 0.25 Link
per request. And remember, the
reason that this cost 0.25 Link
per request versus the price
feeds didn't cost anything is
because the price feeds. If we
look back at a chain that link,
each one of these price feeds is
being sponsored by a group of
protocols who are paying for all
these requests already, since
there isn't a sponsor for this,
we are the only ones requesting
the randomness, we get to be the
ones to actually sponsor getting
this random number, then the
second thing here is going to be
the gas price link. So let's
create another const here to
const. gas price link. But what
this is, is actually a
calculated value is a calculated
value based on the gas price of
the chain. Here's an example if
we were to request a random
number on Aetherium, and the
eath price skyrocketed up to
like to like a billion dollars,
gas would be incredibly,
incredibly expensive. Now when
chain link nodes respond chain
link nodes pay the gas fees, who
give us randomness, and do
external execution, the chain
link nodes are actually the ones
that pay the gas when returning
randomness or executing an
upkeep or etc. If we go to our
raffle dot soul, and scroll down
to perform upkeep, or fulfill
random words, it's actually the
chain link nodes that are
calling these two functions and
paying the gas for it, they get
paid in Oracle gas to offset
those costs. But if the price of
eath, or any native blockchain
skyrocketed the chain that nodes
itself to pay the gas fee. So
the chain link nodes have a
calculated price have a
calculated variable called the
gas price per link, which
fluctuates based off the price
of the actual chain, so that
they never go bankrupt.
Basically, the price of a
request changes based off the
price of gas for that
blockchain, you can kind of
think of this as the link per
gas, if you will, for now we can
kind of just set it to whatever
we want. And we'll just set it
to one e nine, which is going to
be equivalent to 1123456789. So
now that we have the base fee,
and the gas price link, we'll
grab this base fee, we'll have
these be the arguments for our
VR chord, enter V to mock, so
we'll say and actually we can
delete that will say const, args
equals base fee, and gas price
link, then we can take this args
variable and just plop it in
here. Now we can do log mocks
deployed, then we can do log
that a little line like this to
let people know that this deploy
script is done, then we'll just
do a module that exports dot
tags equals all and mocks. So
now that we have a view of
coordinator v2 Mock deployed,
we'll come back over to our
raffle and make some code around
it. Similar to what we just did
with our deploy mocks. We can
say if development chains that
includes network dot name, we'll
do some stuff. And we need to
import development chains from
our helper Hardhead config. And
we need to import network from
hard hat. My VS code
automatically added them Wow,
thanks VS code. Let's even just
do const args and make this
variable down here. Stick it in
args. Our first argument is
going to need to be this Vera fi
to coordinator so let's make a
variable we'll say let VRF core
need torby to address and if
we're on a development chain,
we're going to grab that mock
contract. So we'll say const
PRF, Cor de ATAR V to mock
equals await ethers dot get
contract, the RF cord the cord
to NATO Tor v two MK, and then
we can set the RF coordinator v
two address equals VRF core
denater V two mach dot
address. Cool. We have that
address here. Else if we're not
on a local network, the VRF v2
coordinator address is simply
going to be derived from our
network config. So let's import
the network config as well from
our helper Hardhead config and
we'll say else VRF coordinator
v2 address equals network config
of our chain ID. Let's which
actually sorry, we do need the
chain ID cons chain ID equals
network dot config dot chain ID,
chain ID of VR coordinator V to
chain ID. You're a coordinator
v2. Alright, perfect. We've got
the setup to work with our VRF
coordinator v2 address. What
else do we need from our raffle?
Well, we need an entrance fee,
we probably want to change the
entrance fee depending on what
chain we're on, we're on a more
expensive chain, we might want
to make this higher than others.
So let's go ahead back to our
helper Hardhead config and make
an entrance fee based off of the
blockchain, so for NP, maybe we
want to make it 0.01 eath. So we
could say ethers dot utils,
parse ether of 0.01. And once
again, thank you VS code for
automatically dropping that in
for me. And we're also going to
want an entrance fee for our
heart app, we can also set a
default in here, but let's just
be a little more explicit. So
we'll say 31337. The name of
this is Art app, we don't need
to give it a veneer of
coordinator v2 address because
we're going to deploy a mock.
But we do want an entrance fee.
And let's just give it the exact
same entrance fee here. So we'll
say ethers dot utils dot parse
ether 0.01 E. Alright, great. So
on our deploy here, we can just
say const entrance fee equals
network config. Chain ID of
entrance fee. Let's start
populating our arcs here. So the
first one is going to be your Fe
two coordinator address. Next
one is going to be our entrance
fee. Got it? Got it. Now we need
our gas lane. On Rigby and other
networks, there are different
gas lanes that we can choose
from, let's grab the only gas
Lane from Rinckey, the 30, gray
key hash, let's drop this, of
course into our network config
as gasoline, pop it in here,
we're hard hat, our mock
actually doesn't care what gas
line we're working on, because
we're going to be mocking the
gasoline anyways. So we can just
say gas lane, we can just go
ahead and use the same one or
really anything here, it doesn't
really matter. Now here we'll
say const, gasoline equals
network config.
Chain ID, gasoline, and we'll
grab the gas lane. And we'll
stick it into our argument
array, we've got this one, we've
got this one, we've got this
one. Now it's time for the
subscription ID. Now if you
haven't run through docstoc
chain link for the chain link
VRF, I highly recommend you do
so so that you can understand
what this subscription ID is we
know that we can actually make a
subscription ID using that front
end using that website VRF dot
chain dot link, which is great
and all but what if we're on all
local chains, we can get a
subscription ID no problem in
here. But it's a little bit
harder on a local network. Now
I'm actually going to teach you
how to create and fund
subscription it is completely
programmatically. So you don't
even need to use the UI if you
don't want to. However, for the
purpose of this course, we're
still going to use the user
interface, we're still going to
use that website for us to get
our own subscription IDs. But
you could 100% automate the
process of creating a
subscription ID and funding a
subscription ID. Because when
you create and fund subscription
IDs, you're just calling create
subscription and fund
subscription on that smart
contract. So on our development
chain, we have our V RF
coordinator v2 Mock, and what
we're going to do and on our
development chain, we're going
to create that subscription. So
we're gonna say const,
transaction, response equals
await VRF coordinator v2 Mock
dot create sub scription. And
then we'll run const transaction
receipt equals weight trends
action response, dot Wait, wait
one block confirmation. And
inside this transaction receipt,
there's actually an event that's
emitted with our subscription
that we can get this is another
place where emitting events is
incredibly helpful. So in fact,
if we open back up a Vera v2
coordinator mark, and we look
for create subscription, we see
we emit subscription created
with the subscription ID, we can
actually get this event emitted
from our transaction receipt.
Now to assign it, let's go ahead
and create a sub subscription ID
up here. And then we'll say
subscription ID equals
transaction receipt that events
of zero dot args dot sub ID. And
again, be sure to watch that
events video if you want to
learn more about how to work
with events in hardware. Now
that we have a subscription, we
need to fund the subscription on
a real network, you'd need the
link token to actually fund the
subscription. The current
iteration of the mock allows you
to fund a subscription without
the link token. So what we can
do is we can just run a wait
your F corps inator Mark, if
coordinator B to Mach dot fund
subscription, and we'll give it
the subscription ID and we'll
need to do some fundamental
this, we can just create some
variable, we'll say const VRF,
subscription fund amount equals
ethers dot utils, dot parse
ether, of, we'll say 30 VRF
subscription, fundament. We'll
just paste that down here. We
could do this as well for a real
test net or live networks. But
just so that we become familiar
with the user interface, we're
not going to do a test net
programmatically. And for a test
net, we're just going to use
exactly what we've been doing so
far. Or we can put a
subscription ID and our helper
config. So we'll say
subscription ID, we'll put
something in here right now,
we'll just leave it as zero. But
later on, when we actually
create a subscription, we'll
update our subscription ID. And
so we'll say subscription ID
equals network config. Change ID
of subscription ID. Perfect. Now
we can add this to our arguments
array. What else do we need
subscription ID, we need a
callback gas limit or callback,
gas limit is going to vary
network to network. So once
again, we're gonna go into our
helper configure callback gas
limit. And for us, we'll set a
pretty high limit of 500,000
gas. So we'll say call a gas
limit of 5.123 500,000. Gas. And
for hard hat, we'll do the same
thing. So we can say const,
callback, gas limit equals
network config, chain ID,
callback, gas limit, grab this,
put it into our argument array.
What else do we need? All we
need now is the interval. So we
can change this network to
network as well. Rigby will say,
interval will ever just be 30
seconds for both hard hat and
for Rigby. So we'll do the same
thing here. Say const.
Interval equals network config.
Chain ID, interval, and we'll
grab this, pop it in the end of
our array. All right, awesome.
Now we have an argument array
and drop it right in here and
perfect. Everything in our
constructor for our raffle
contract. Great. This is looking
fantastic. We've got wait
confirmations we got logging
arguments Deployer. Okay, well,
what next? Well, let's go ahead
and add that verification piece.
So once again, create a new
folder utils, new file
verify.js. We can either copy
paste this from our last
project, or we can grab this
from the GitHub repo associated
with this course, once we have
our verify script in here, we're
going to import it by saying
const. Verify equals require dot
dot slash helper Hardhead
config. And then we can add that
same bit of code down here to
verify our contract, we'll say
if we're not on a development
chain. And we have process
studying v dot ether scan API
key, then we're going to log
verifying dot dot and then await
verify raffle dot address and
the arcs. Now we'll just do a
log of a whole bunch of hyphens
say that this script is done
module dot exports dot tags
equals say this will be all and
raffle. All right, so let's test
this out. We'll do hardhat
deploy, or yarn, hard hat deploy
and see if this script works
correctly. Looks like we ran
into an error network config not
defined. So let's spell this
right. Network config. There we
go. And that looks much better.
Let's try this again. It looks
like our deploy scripts are
working well. local networks
protected, deploying mocks
deployed VRF coordinator v2 Mock
mocks deployed and then we went
ahead and deployed our raffle.
Awesome, this is massive. Now
we're not going to test the
deploying this to a test net
quite yet, because well, we
don't have any unit tests yet.
We need to write unit tests
before we want to ever test
running this on a test net. So
we have our deploy script, we
have our contracts, that means
it's time for us to write some
tests. We'll come over here
we'll create a new folder called
test. And for now, we'll just
make our unit tests. So unit
tests, and in here we create a
new file called raffle.test.js.
And let's write some unit tests.
Now for these unit tests, we are
going to be a little bit verbose
here, we're going to make our
coverage really, really good
here. It's not gonna be perfect,
but this is going to be pretty
verbose. So I'm gonna go pretty
quickly here. So you can feel
free to pause, slow me down,
speed me up whatever you need to
learn this section. It is really
good muscle memory to go through
writing these tests and
understand what you should be
thinking about when you're
writing these tests. So feel
free to speed up the parts You
already know and slow down the
new parts. Because we are going
to go over some new information
here. writing tests may seem
like a tedious process. But I
promise as you get better at
writing these tests, you'll
realize that these are the
things that you can rely on when
stuff doesn't work. And when
you're not sure how to code,
something, getting this muscle
memory down, writing these tests
is going to make you a fantastic
engineer. So let's go through
and we'll write some of these
verbose tests here to try to
make this really good and have
this have really good coverage.
And if you want to go back later
on, and see if you can give it
even more coverage, and even
better tests, please feel free
to do so. But let's get started.
Let's write some tests. So we're
going to start out pretty much
the same way we've been starting
everything out, we're going to
grab our development chains, so
that we only run our unit tests
on a development chain. So we'll
do const development chains,
equals require dot dot slash dot
dot slash helper, RD, hard hat
config, and then we'll say not
development chains, that
includes network dot name, and
describe that skip. Otherwise,
we'll do describe, so this first
describe is going to be our
raffle unit tests. And this is
going to be an async. function.
So raffle unit tests so that it
comes on the next line, it looks
a little bit better. Alright,
great. Now, what are some of the
main things that we're going to
need to deploy? Well, we're
gonna need to deploy a raffle,
we're probably going to want a
VRF core to a tour be to mock
graded before each, that's going
to be an async function, where
we go ahead and we get these
will say const. Employer equals
await, get named accounts.
So we're gonna need to import
get named accounts or require
get name accounts from hard hat,
then we're going to want to
deploy these using our fixtures.
So we can say await deployments.
And then we're going to import
deployments as well from hardhat
dot fixture, and we're going to
call all, we're going to deploy
everything. And again, if we
look at our one, our raffle has
the alt tag, and our Oh, our
mocks also have the alt tag,
okay, perfect. Once we deploy
everything, we can say raffle
equals await ethers dot get to
contract. And we got to import
ethers from hard hat, like so.
And we'll say it will get the
raffle contract and we'll
connect it to our Deployer. And
then we're going to do the same
thing with VRF coordinator v2
Mock equals await ethers dot get
contract, the RF coordinator, B
to MK connect this to deployer
as well. Alright, great, our
first set of tests describe,
they're going to be the
constructor. And this is going
to be an async function. And
let's do this. Let's create an
IT initial initializes the
raffle correctly, this is going
to be an async function. Now I
just want to make a note,
because ideally, we make our
tests have just one assert, or
it just keep that in mind is
that ideally, we want to have
just one assert for it. But
we're going to have a bunch
because like I said, we're being
a little bit loose here. So we
want to just make sure that our
raffle is initialized correctly.
So we'll say const raffle state,
and we'll get that raffle state
because we want to make sure
that we start in an open raffle
state. So we'll say const,
raffle state equals await raffle
dot get raffle state. And then
we want to say assert dot equal
ope and then we need to import
assert from Chai. So assert
equals require Chai assert dot
equal raffle state.to string
because again, raffle state is
going to be a big number. And
even though a raffle state is of
type raffle state, it'll return
a zero if it's open and a one if
it's calculating. So this gets
transformed just into a un 256.
When we call it like this, a
raffle state variable here will
be a big number. So we want to
just to string a file. So assert
dot equal raffle state DOT two
string zero. We'll also make
sure our interval gets set
correctly. So we'll do const
interval equals await raffle dot
get interval. And I don't know
if we have one of those it's
actually C inter ball see if we
have one of those. We don't have
a good interval let's go ahead
and add again interval function
so we'll do function get in
trouble. We have public view
returns you went to six return I
underscore interval will have
good interval will say raffle
dot get interval and will also
say assert dot equal interval.to
string. It should equal one Ever
is in our helper config, right?
Because we're using the interval
and helper config. So we say
interval.to string should equal.
So we'll import that as well.
Network config. And we'll say
the interval should equal
network config. Of let's also
make, get our chain ID up here,
chain ID, say const. Chain ID
equals network dot config, a
chain ID, network config of the
chain ID of interval. Alright,
cool. So let's test this so far,
HH test or yarn, hard hat test.
And cool looks like it passed.
And we have our little gas
output here. Awesome. Let's go
to our Hardhead config, just so
that it doesn't always print out
at gas, but there for now. So
I'm going to copy paste the gas
reporter section from our last
project, like so. And we're
going to have enabled gas be
false for now. So now if we run
a Hardhead test, again, we
shouldn't have that gas bid
printed out, we should just see
the tests and perfect, that's
what we see. And our constructor
test passes. Yay, what's next,
got our constructor. And we
probably could have written more
tests for the rest of these. But
let's just move on. Alright,
enter raffle, that's going to be
our next describe block. So it
will do describe,
enter, raffle. And this is going
to be an async function. And
we'll say it reverts when you
don't pay enough, right, because
one of the first things that we
check is that they're paying
enough. So we want to make sure
that this actually reverts if
they don't pay enough. So this
will be an async function. Where
we're going to do that same
expect await thing. So we're
going to import expect from
Chai, which comes from those
waffle matchers. And we're gonna
say await, expect raffle dot
enter a raffle. And we're not
going to pass any value here,
we're going to expect it to dot
b dot reverted with. And if we
look here, we want it to be
reverted with this raffle not
enough eath entered. So we can
put that in quotes raffle not
enough eath entered. Now we can
try this out. Make sure that it
actually works. Ah ah test dash
dash grep. Put this in quotes
that you don't pay enough. And
awesome. We're passing there.
What else do we want to test?
Well, we want to test that if
the raffle isn't open, we also
revert but we'll test that in a
little bit. As we kind of test
the rest of the functionality.
We want to see that it records
players when they enter. So this
will be an async function. And
now we'll enter the raffle.
First we're going to need that
raffle entrance fee. Let's go
ahead and save that at the top.
So we'll say let raffle VRF
coordinator be to mock raffle
entrance fee and then our before
each will say raffle entrance
fee equals a weight ethers dot
get entrance fee. This should be
raffle dot get entrance fee. So
now we have this raffle entrance
fee, you can use it to enter the
raffle we'll say a weight raffle
dot enter raffle with a value of
raffle entrance fee. And we can
make sure that our Deployer here
has been correctly recorded. So
since right now we're connected
to the Deployer. We'll just make
sure that that deployer actually
is in our contract. So we'll say
const player from contract
equals await raffle dot get
player of zero, because we
record them in our players array
and we have our get players
function which pulls them out.
And then we'll say assert dot
equal player, player from
contract should be the Deployer.
So now we can grep for this in
our hard head test. Make sure
this works. HH test dash dash
grep. Deployer is not defined.
We've got it up here. But we
actually didn't save it
globally. So we got to do let
common Deployer. And we'll say
deployer equals await get named
accounts. And we'll wrap it like
this to get the deployer
Awesome. Let's try this again.
And awesome. What else should
this do? Well, it's also
emitting an event. So let's make
sure it emits an event. So we'll
say it emits event on enter.
This will be an async function
as well. And this will be the
first time that we're testing to
make sure a function emits an
event and the syntax is going to
look really similar to what we
test for when we check to see if
an error is fired. So we're
gonna say await expect raffle
dot enter raffle with value of
raffle entrance fee dot two dot
omit and this.to dot emit we get
from During woful, these chime
matches for emitting events we
can do a wait expect to emit,
and then the event that we're
expecting to emit. So we're
saying to omit the raffle
contract to emit a raffle enter
event. We can copy this, try to
test this in our terminal. So
we'll say hard hat. Test dash
dash grep. Just put this in
quotes. And that passes as well.
Great. Let's now go ahead and
test to make sure that we can't
enter the raffle whenever this
raffle is not open or it's
calculating. So we'll say it
doesn't allow entrance, when
raffle is Cal cumulating. And
this will be an async function.
And first we'll enter will say
await raffle dot enter raffle
value is raffle entrance fee.
Now what we want to do we want
to get this raffle into a closed
state. So we want to get it out
of its open state. Well, how do
we move this raffle from raffle
dot open to raffle dot closed in
perform upkeep, remove the
raffle from raffle that open to
raffle dot calculating but
perform upkeep can only be
called if check upkeep returns
true. Otherwise, it'll revert
with raffle upkeep not needed.
So what we need to do is we need
to make check upkeep return
true. And we will pretend to be
the channeling keeper network to
keep calling checkup keep
waiting for it to be true. And
once we make it true, then we'll
pretend to be the channeling
keepers and call perform upkeep
to put this contract in a state
of calculating. Now how do we
actually do that? Well, in order
for checkup keep to be true, we
first need to see that we are
indeed open, which we are. The
next thing that we need to do
though, is we need to do this
time passed bit. We need to
actually wait that 30 seconds
for time to pass. Now, that kind
of sounds awful. Do we have to
wait 30 seconds for all of our
tests? What if our interval was
10 days when we have to wait 10
days to run our tests? It sounds
ridiculous. Well, hard hat
actually comes built in with a
ton of functions for us to
manipulate our blockchain to do
literally whatever we want it to
do. In the hard hat
documentation. There's a section
called Hard Hat Network
reference inside the Hard Hat
Network section. And in here,
there's a ton of information
about how the hard hat network
actually works and different
configs that we can do with it.
If we scroll down low enough, we
can see the JSON RPC methods
that we can use on this
blockchain, we can do eath
accounts block number call
chinetti. We can do all these
RPC methods that a normal
blockchain has. Additionally, we
can do even more than that, we
can use these things called Hard
Hat Network methods. Since this
is our local Hard Hat Network.
And we're using this for
testing, we want to be able to
test any scenario. And it's
these methods that give us the
ability to do that, you can go
through this and play around and
see all the different things you
can do. One of them in
particular is going to be set
storage set where you can set
storage at any place, which is
really fun. But some of the
special testing debugging
methods are going to be EVM
increase time, and EVM. Mine
increased time allows us to
automatically increase the time
of our blockchain and EVM. Mine
allows us to mine or create new
blocks, because if we increase
the time, it doesn't do anything
unless there's a new block
mined. So what we can do is we
can run a wait network, and
we'll import network from Hard
Hat Network await network dot
provider that send EVM in crease
time, comma, we can send a list
of parameters to send with it,
which for us are just going to
be our interval.to number. And
then we'll do plus one. Now
right now, our interval isn't
stored globally, so we're
probably going to want to do
that. So let's go ahead and do
interval. And then in our before
each, we'll do interval equals
await, raffle dot raffle dot get
interval, I'm just going to copy
this and we're going to delete
this whole line. Wait raffle dot
get interval. Since now we're
just going to call it interval
at a global level, since we're
going to use it a lot. Now we're
gonna say interval that to
number plus one. So we want to
increase the time by whatever
our interval is to make sure
that we can actually get that
checkup keep to return true. So
additionally, we're going to
want to do a weight network dot
provider. Dot send EVM mine with
an empty array just because we
just want to mine it one extra
block. You can also do network
dot provider that request with
an await here, these two would
be basically the same, but this
one's a little quicker, right?
So we've increased the time of
our blockchain. We've mined a
block to move forward. It should
be open time has passed. Do we
have a player? We do indeed,
because we've entered the
raffle. We should have a balance
because we've entered the right
Apple, check upkeep should now
return true. So we should be
able to call perform upkeep and
pretend to be a chain lock
keeper. So we're going to
pretend to be a chain the keeper
and call await raffle dot
perform upkeep. And we're going
to pass this some empty call
data just by passing a blank
array like that. And now this
should be in a calculating
state. So now that it's in a
calculating state, we can say
our enter raffle reverts
correctly if the raffle isn't
open. So now we'll say await,
expect raffle dot enter, raffle.
And we'll send it value of
raffle entrance fee. We're
expecting this.to dot b dot
reverted with that raffle
underscore underscore not open
error. Okay, let's try just this
in our tests now. So we'll run
Hardhead test dash dash grep.
Put this in quotes. And perfect
that passes as well.
Now if we run Hardhead test,
let's just test everything
together right now. And
everything is passing. Oh, this
is wonderful. Awesome. Let's
keep it going. And if we run
Hardhead coverage, we'll see our
coverage is bumping up, we are
already drastically better than
where we were before. Let's keep
going well, let's go ahead and
test our check upkeep now. So
we'll do describe, check upkeep.
And this will be an async
function,
where we'll say it returns
false. If people have been sent
an E, E, it's been a sync
function.
So we'll have everything in here
be true except for the fact that
nobody's entered yet. So we'll
do a weight network dot provider
dot send EVM increase time,
comma interval.to number plus
one
will do a weight network dot
provider. That send UVM mine. No
parameters. Now we're going to
call check upkeep. Now here's
the thing, check. upkeep is a
public function.
So if we just run await, raffle
dot check upkeep, and we pass
nothing in this is going to kick
off a transaction, because hard
had knows Oh, okay, it's a
public function, they're clearly
trying to send a transaction
here. If this was a public view
function, it wouldn't, it would
return that view. But the thing
is, I don't really want to send
a transaction. But I want to
simulate sending this
transaction and seeing what this
upkeep needed would return.
Well, I can actually get that by
using something called call
static, I can simulate calling
this transaction and seeing what
it will respond. So instead of
raffle dot, check upkeep, I can
do raffle dot cost static, that
check upkeep. And this will give
me the return of upkeep needed
and the bytes perform data, I
can extrapolate just the upkeep
needed out of this return or
writing const upkeep needed
equals this, and then I can do
assert not upkeep needed,
because right now upkeep needed
to return false. So we'll say
assert, not false, which is
true. If upkeep needed was true,
then this would be false. And
this would break. So that's what
we want to do. So let's go
ahead, we'll run this, see if it
worked. Our hat test, dash dash
grep. And we're in passing, we
are in business. Awesome. So
this is working perfectly. Well,
and let's also test that it
returns false. If raffle isn't
open. This will be an async
function. And we'll do
everything except and we'll do
everything in here. But we'll
make the raffle in the
calculating state. So do a
weight, raffle dot enter, raffle
value, raffle entrance fee await
network dot provider that send
and I'm just going to copy these
two lines here. Because we're
going to go ahead and do those.
We're also going to do a weight,
raffle dot perform upkeep. And
another way to send a blank
bytes object is to do a string
like 0x hardhat is smart enough
to know that this should be
transformed into just kind of a
blank bytes object. So either
one of these should work. Now
we're do const, raffle state
equals await, raffle dot get
raffle state and we'll Get
upkeep needed. So we'll say
const. upkeep needed, we'll do
exactly what we did above raffle
dot call static dot check
upkeep. Let's say excuse me a
weight, raffle dot call static.
Now we can do assert dot equal,
say raffle state is going to be,
or excuse me raffle state.to
string, it's going to be
calculating, and I started dot
equal upkeep needed, it's going
to be false. Let's run a GREP on
that. And perfect. That's also
working correctly. Great. Now
I'm going to skip over these
next two tests, because we
haven't really learned anything
from them. So I'm just going to
copy paste them from the GitHub,
we're going to return false if
enough time hasn't passed. And
we're going to return true. If
enough time has passed, we have
players Eve and is open. So
we're just asserting true down
here. And we're starting not
true up here, you want to pause
the video and copy paste these
and write these out, you
absolutely can copy paste them
from the GitHub repo, you
absolutely can't like I said,
going through this and making
yourself write these and making
yourself understand these tests
is going to make you a
substantially better coder. And
let's just test that it all
looks good with hh test. Now, as
I was recording this, I just
realized that for all of our
describe blocks, I've been
making them async functions
describe blocks actually don't
realize and can't recognize and
can't work with promises. So
having the be async actually
doesn't do anything. So in your
describe block, we want to get
rid of the async word because
it's actually not helping us at
all. In fact, it's just an extra
word, and it looks kind of
gross. So now all of our
describe blocks, we're gonna get
rid of that async keyword, and
just have them be functions. Of
course, all of our it's, though,
are going to be using
asynchronous functions, which is
what we want. So we've written
some tests for a checkup keep.
Now let's go ahead to perform
upkeep.
Let's create a new describe,
block, ascribe or perform
upkeep. This is going to be a
regular function. And in here,
we're going to start and say it
can only run if check upkeep is
true. And this will be an async
function. Because we only want
to perform keep to work if
checkup keep is indeed true. So
we'll say await raffle dot
enter. raffle we'll send it some
value, raffle entrance fee, I'm
sorry, there should be curly
braces instead. And we'll do a
weight network dot provider that
send EVM increase time inter
vol.to number plus one await
network dot provider that send
UVM mine an empty array there to
the reason that we're moving
time forward and moving our
block forward, of course is
gonna be the same thing as
above, we want our check upkeep
to return true. And then we're
gonna say const X or transaction
equals await raffel dot perform
upkeep. We can either do a blank
array, or we could do 0x Doesn't
matter. And we can assert the X.
Now if TX doesn't work, or this
error is out or something, this
will fail. Right. So that's how
we know that this actually can
work. So let's test this out. We
want this only to work if
checkup keep is true. And we
made checkup keep true by all
the stuff that we did above. So
now we'll do yarn hardhat test
dash dash grep with our IT block
here. And I spelled perform
upkeep wrong perform upkeep.
Let's try spelling things
correctly. And let's run that
test again. And great. That's
working. I will What else do we
want to do? We want it to revert
with raffel. upkeep not needed
if checkup keep is false. So in
here we're gonna say it reverts.
When check up keep is false.
This will be an async function.
And we're going to do that same
syntax await expect raffle dot
perform upkeep empty bytes
object that to.be reverted with.
And what do we want it to be
reverted with? Or hoping it's
reverted with this with that, we
can run this test here Hardhead
test dash dash grep paste that
in. And we see that is indeed
passing now something that
you'll notice here is that our
revert actually goes ahead and
reverts with all this extra
stuff as well. Our test is smart
enough to know that if all we do
is put the name of the error
that is getting reverted with
then it's good enough. If we
want to be super specific, we
can actually go ahead and make
this a string interpolation and
add all of these in here. So we
can add the balance that we
expect we can add the players
that we expect. And we can add
the raffle statement for now
we're just going to keep it as
we're expecting this but if you
want to be super specific you
can have your tests expect for
exactly the specific values that
you're looking for. But alright,
what is the last thing we should
expect form? Well, we should
check to see that this actually
gets called the raffle state
gets changed. And we admit this
event. So let's go ahead and add
that. We'll say it updates the
raffle state admits an event and
calls the VRF coordinator to be
an async function as well. Let's
do this. So let's go ahead and
let's make checkup keep true,
I'm just going to copy paste
these first three lines, since
it's going to be exactly the
same. We're going to enter the
raffle we're going to increase
the time we're going to mind a
new block, then we're going to
call perform upkeep. So we're
going to say const, TX response
equals await raffle dot perform
upkeep with an empty bytes
object, and we're going to do
const TX receipt equals await TX
response dot wait for one block.
From this receipt, we're gonna
get the request ID, we're gonna
say const Request ID equals, we
can get the request ID. From
this omitted event. However, we
should look at our VRF
coordinator mock again, when we
call request random words, both
in the mock and then in the
actual contract, you'll notice
that it also emits an event with
random words requested. And if
you look in here, the second
parameter that it has is indeed
the request ID. So in reality,
US omitting the request ID is
redundant, we can just use the
admitted Request ID from the VRF
coordinator for the purpose of
this course and showing you what
an event looks like. We're going
to leave it in there. But if you
want to go back and refactor
this, you would definitely want
to remove this omit. But for
this test, let's do TX receipt
dot events. And this is going to
be the first event instead of
the zero with event because
before this event gets emitted,
this function is going to emit
an event. So instead of the zero
with event, this is the first
event that gets emitted after
this one. So tax receipts dot
events of one dot args dot
request, ID, and then we're
gonna say cert request id.to
number is greater than zero. And
then we'll also assert that the
raffle state equals equals one.
So we're gonna do const, raffle
state equals await, raffle dot
get raffle state. And this
should actually be raffle
state.to Number, or to string
and then you know, do whatever
we want to do. And this is a
very big it, but we're going to
copy the whole thing anyways. HH
test, dash dash grep, paste that
in there, we run it, excuse
me.to string equals equals one,
transformer time and perfect, we
are passing Great, now it's time
for fulfill random words. And
this is where we're going to
learn a lot of fantastic stuff
here. So we're gonna make a new
describe block zoomed out a
little bit here. And this is
going to be our fulfill random
words. It's going to be a
function, of course. And in
here, we're actually going to
add another before each want to
have somebody have entered the
raffle before we run any tests
in here. So we're going to do a
before each, which will be an
async. function. And we're just
going to run await, raffle that
enter raffle with a value of
raffle entrance fee. And then
we're going to do a wait network
dot provider dot send EVM
increase time of interval, that
to number plus one, and then a
wait network dot provider dot
send EVM mine. Comma. Before
we've tried to do any testing of
or fulfilled random words, we're
gonna have somebody enter the
lottery. And we're going to have
increased the time and mined a
new block. Okay, cool. So the
first thing we want to do is
want to see that fulfill random
words can only be called so long
as there's a request in flight,
so long as there's a requested
as long as request random words
has been called. So we can
actually check that by running
it can only be called after
perform. This will be an async
function. And in here, we're
going to revert on some requests
that don't exist. So we'll do
await, expect the RF core didn't
a tour be to mock dot fulfill
random words. And if we look at
our V RF, coordinator v2 Mark in
here has the fulfill random
words function, which is what
the chain link node actually
calls and inside Add this
function in the actual contract
calls another contract that does
the random number verification.
So we're basically checking this
part right here. If the request
doesn't exist, we're going to
get this non existent request
here. And as you can see, it
needs a request ID and a
consumer address. So we're going
to guess zero. And the consumer
addresses, of course, it's gonna
be raffled out at address, we're
going to expect this to be
reverted, with non existent
request. And then we're going to
do this exact same thing with a
different Request ID or request
ID one. And hopefully, we're
also going to get non existent
requests. Now ideally, no
request here would ever allow
this fulfill random words to go
through. Now, it obviously would
be really hard for us to test
every single possible Request
ID, we're going to see a way in
the future to actually test for
a ton of these variables with
something called fuzz testing.
But we'll get to that in the
future. And I spelt the scribe
wrong, let's let's actually
spelled the scribe correctly, go
ahead and run this hh test dash
dash grep.
And great it passed. Now I'm
going to make just one more test
here, that's gonna be way too
big. But right now the test that
we're about to write is going to
be it's going to be a really big
test. And we probably want to
split it up into different
sections, but actually figured
that this was actually the best
way to show this section. And
it's going to be exactly what
we're going to do. When we get
to our staging test, we're going
to write this test literally
almost exactly the same. So
let's write it, this is
basically going to be the test
that puts everything together.
So we're going to test that this
indeed, so winner resets the
lottery, and sends money, which
is kind of a lot for a single
it, we probably would want to
split those into their own
pieces. But for this, we're just
going to put them all into one,
and it's going to be an async
function. Now we are going to
learn a couple of new tricks
here. So definitely be sure to
follow along. Now for this one,
we're also going to add in some
additional entrances additional
people who are entering this
lottery. So we'll say const,
additional, and trance equals
great. We're gonna have some
more of those fake accounts from
ethers enter our lottery here.
So we're gonna say const.
Starting account, index equals
to, since deployer equals zero,
excuse me equals one, since the
player is zero, so we're going
to have new accounts start from
index one. And we're going to do
a little for loop or let i
equals starting count index, i
is less than the starting count,
index, plus additional and trend
sees there's gonna be entrance.
i plus plus, we're gonna do a
little loop and connect our
raffle contract to these new
accounts. And then we're going
to have these new accounts,
enter our raffle contest. Count,
connected raffle equals raffle
dot connect accounts of i and do
we have accounts defined
somewhere we don't. So let's get
accounts to find somewhere.
We'll say const accounts equals
await ethers dot get signers.
And then we're going to do a
weight account connected raffle
dot enter. raffle with a value
of course of raffle entrance
fee,
we're going to connect three
additional entrance to our
raffle. So we're going to have a
total of four people connect
into this raffle. Now that we
have them in here, we're going
to keep note of our starting
timestamp. So we're gonna do
const starting timestamp equals
await, raffle dot get last
timestamp. And here's where
we're going to get a little bit
tricky. What we want to do is a
couple of things we want to we
want to perform upkeep, which is
going to mock being chainlink
keepers, which will kick off the
chain link, which will kick off
calling fulfill random words.
And we're going to mock doing
that as well. Mock being the
chain link VRF. Once we do that,
we can of course just check to
see okay, did the recent winner
get recorded the raffle get
reset just play as we said as
the timestamp is everything
reset. But we want to do this in
a specific way. If we're doing
this on a test net after we call
fulfill random words, we will
have to wait for the fulfill
random words to be called. Now
since we're working with a
hardhat local chain, we don't
really need to wait for
anything, right because we can
just say okay, boom, snap our
fingers and adjust our
blockchain to do whatever we
want. But we're going to
simulate that we do need to wait
for that event to be called. So
in order for us to simulate
waiting for that event, we once
again need to set up a listener.
Now if we set up a listener we
don't want this to Just to
finish before the listener has
is done listening, so we need to
once again create a new promise.
And this is going to be
incredibly important, especially
for our staging tests. So we're
going to do await, new promise.
And this is going to be exactly
the same as we set it up before,
it's going to be an async
function that's going to take
resolve and reject as
parameters. And we're going to
use this little arrow syntax
here saying, this is an async
function, basically, and we're
going to set up once again, that
once syntax, we're gonna say
raffle that once, what's the
event name, winner picked. So
we're gonna say, Listen, for
this winner picked event, we're
gonna say raffle dot once winner
picks happens, do some stuff.
And again, this is just an
anonymous function. So we're
gonna say raffle dot once the
winner picked event gets
emitted, do some stuff. So we're
setting this up. Now it's in
this function, we're going to
add all of our certs and
everything because we want to
wait for winter to get picked.
Now before the event gets fired,
though, we of course, need to
actually call perform and call
fulfill random words. So this is
going to seem like it's a little
bit backwards. But that's
because we want to set up our
listeners so that when we do
fire, the methods that will fire
the event, our listener is
activated and is waiting for it.
So we're going to put all of our
code inside of this promise.
Now, because we put it outside
of the promise, we put all the
code outside of the promise,
this promise will never get
resolved, because the listener
will never fire into vent. So if
down here, you know we call
fulfill random words with
something, you know which the
spelling is bad. But let's say
we call the down here, this
piece of code will never reach
this fulfill random words,
because it's always going to be
waiting for this wants to get
resolved. So we need to add all
of our code inside the promise.
But outside this raffle dot once
now we don't want to wait
forever, right? Maybe there is
an issue here. And we want to be
able to reject this, if there's
an issue. Now what we can do is
in our heart hat dot config, we
can add a timeout. So we can add
this mocha section, we can give
ourselves a timeout of 200,000
milliseconds, which is going to
be 200 seconds max, if this
event doesn't get fired in 200
seconds, this will be considered
a failure and this test will
fail, which is what we want. And
I typically like to just wrap
this in a try catch because if
something fails, it'll cause you
a whole bunch of headache catch
E. And if anything fails, we'll
also reject, there's an issue
with us calling some function,
we'll just say, Hey, okay,
that's a failure. But you fail,
that way, our promise can get
resolved in a timely manner,
we're going to add this code in
a little bit. But let's keep
going. Let's keep going. And
excuse me, the trycatch should
be in the ones, the ones above
the results, excuse me, because
this is the listener. So sorry,
we want the trycatch to be
inside the ones if this takes
too long, we want to just go
ahead and throw an error.
Otherwise, we're going to
resolve now outside the
listener, but inside of the
promise, we're going to do this
bit here, where we go const TX
equals await raffle dot perform
upkeep, and we'll pass it the
empty bytes object, we'll get
const TX receipt equals await TX
dot weight of one block.
And then we're going to do a
weight VRF core didn't a tour be
to mock dot fulfill random
words, CX receipt dot events of
one dot args dot Request ID come
a raffle that address. So then
the final thing that we're going
to do is we're going to get this
veer off coordinator be to mock
we're going to have it call
fulfill random words, which
takes the request ID and the
consumer address. So we're going
to mock it, give it the request
ID which we get from the
transaction receipt, and the
consumer address here. All
inside this promise, we're
setting up a listener for this
winner picked event. And then
we're mocking the channeling
keepers and then we're mocking
the chainlink VRF. And once this
function gets called this
function should emit a winner
picked event. So this raffle
that was set up that was
listening for this to get
emitted will pick up and go Ah
okay, I found it I found the
winner picked event. Now we can
go ahead and do some stuff. So
once the winner picked event
gets fired, we'll do a little
console dot log found the event
like this and we'll jump into
our try catch and this trycatch
is going to be basically us
doing all these asserts in here.
So first we want to say const
recent winner equals await
raffle dot get recent winner and
we're going to be checking just
everything in this raffle right
we're gonna be checking that the
recent winners right that that
the raffle state's been reset
the players have reversed, you
know, players has been reset,
etc, etc. So we'll say const
raffle state equals awaits
raffle dot get raffle state
we'll say const. Ending
timestamp equals await, raffle
dot get last timestamp. And
let's start doing some asserts.
So first we should assert that
this es players array has been
reset to zero. So if we call get
number of players it should be
zero. So we can do const num
players equals await raffle dot
get number of players like so.
And we can do assert dot equal
nine players.to string is going
to be zero. What else can we
assert? Well, we can assert dot
equal raffle state should be
back to being open. So raffle
state.to string should be zero,
we should assert that the ending
timestamp is now greater than
the starting timestamp. Because
the last timestamp should have
been updated. We also want to
make sure our recent winner is
correct. But we'll do console
dot log recent winner. Now we
can go to the VRF coordinator
mock. And we could simulate this
and try to figure out who the
random winner is to console dot
log accounts to. And then just
to show a bunch of them, we'll
do 01 and three a raffle dot
once this needs to be an async
function, not just a regular
function. Let's try that one
more time, get latest timestamp
is the correct function. So
let's update this with the
correct latest. Let's put latest
in there. Because I'm spelling
something's wrong. I sure am
looks like we're printing out
recent winner here when we
haven't even initialized it. So
let's move it up. And then we'll
do console dot log recent
winner. So I know this is a
massive test here. But let's
give it a try and see if
everything kind of does what we
think it should do. And it's
slowing down here, which is good
because we're doing a lot of
stuff. And uh huh, we finally
get this passing thing to come
out. And we did a ton of console
dot logging so so there's a lot
of stuff in here of the signers
are getting printed out. So
let's just make this a little
easier to read. We'll add dot
address to all these, we can see
who the winner is. So it looks
like the winner is going to be
account number one, which is
great. So what we can do now
that we know account number one
is going to be the winner, we
can get that winners starting
balance way down here before we
call fulfill random words. So
we'll say const winner, starting
balance equals await accounts
one dot get balance, yes, you
can just call get balance right
like that. And now that we have
the winner starting balance back
in our tests, we can say const
winner, ending balance equals
await ounce one dot get balance.
And we can make sure that this
winner got paid what they need.
So now we're going to do a big
assert with some money stuff,
just trust me, this is what the
math is. So we're going to do
assert dot equal winner
balance.to string,
excuse me winter ending
balance.to string should equal
the winner starting balance dot
add the raffle entrance fee that
multiplied by the additional and
trance that add the raffle
entrance fee that we paid.to
string. So this math is
basically saying the winner
should end with a balance of all
of the money that everybody else
added to this contract. And
that's it. So we can run this
test one more time. And Gosh,
darn it, it passed. Okay, so
there was a lot of code here.
And this might have been one of
the hardest pieces of this
entire course is going to be
this part right here. So if you
struggled a little bit with
this, don't let that bog you
down. This is probably one of
the more difficult sections of
this course, let's do a quick
refresher of just this test that
we're doing. And then we'll see
in an action when we do it. In
our staging test. What we did is
we're picking a winner resetting
the lottery and we're sending
money. Basically what we're
doing is we're testing that this
fulfill random words thing does
what we want it to do a random
winner wins and they get the
money. So how do we actually do
that? Well, we first started off
by having a bunch of random
people enter the lottery. Great.
Sounds good. Now what we wanted
to do was we want to call
perform upkeep and fulfill
random words, we want to pretend
that the random number was
drawn. And that's what this code
down here does is it calls that
random number but and what we
could have done was we could
have had all these assert and
checked all the variables. After
we did this, right. We could
have totally done that. However,
on a test net where we don't
always know exactly when a
transaction is going to finish.
We have to wait If we have to
listen for an event to be fired,
before, we could call the
transactions that would end this
whole thing, we needed to set
something up to listen for that
event to be fired. And we said,
hey, only once this event is
fired only once this transaction
is called, can we do our testing
now for our local network, we
are mocking the VRF
coordinators, we have control,
we know exactly when this is
going to run. But on a test net,
we don't. So you'll see in our
staging tests, we won't have any
of this here. And we'll have to
rely on setting up a listener to
listen for the channeling VRF
and the keepers to fire their
events. And that's why the
staging test is going to be so
important to make sure that
we're doing everything correct.
And that's why we set up our
local tests like this, so that
it mimics what we're going to be
doing on our statement test what
we're going to be doing on a
real network here. And again,
we're setting up this listener
and we're saying, Ah, once we do
here, this event, then we're
going to try to actually check
all of the balances and check
that everything is working as
intended. And if we don't see
it, we're going to reject. And
if there's a timeout, if it
takes more than 200 seconds,
we're going to say okay,
something went wrong, we're
going to cancel it. And
actually, I'm going to bump this
up to 300 seconds, because I
think 200 seconds is not going
to be enough. And depending on
how quick the rink B test that
is, you might have to bump this
up even bigger. So just keep
that in mind. But who, okay, we
have just built some fantastic
tests. Let's go ahead, and let's
just run h h test to see if all
of our tests are going to pass.
And well, 14 passing, everything
is passing here we are looking
good.
This is fantastic. Alright, so
now that we have our unit tests,
let's go ahead and create a
staging test. Our staging test
is going to look really similar
to that massive test that we
just created down here. And the
reason we set up our unit test
to do this a weight promise
thing with the raffle dot once
was because this is actually how
we're going to need to wait on a
test net or main net for a
winner to be picked. We cannot
on an actual test net, pretend
to be the chain link V REF, we
can pretend to be the chain link
keepers if we want. But we're
not going to make sure that the
10 the keepers is actually
working. But we are going to be
doing this because we want to
listen for that event to be
fired, we want to listen for the
chain link VRF to respond with
the winner. So let's create a
staging test. And this is a test
that we're going to run on an
actual test net here. Okay, so
we're going to create a new test
called raffle dot staging dot
test dot Jas and this is where
we're going to put our staging
test. Now we can actually code
this pretty quickly because most
of our staging tests is gonna
look real similar to our raffle
test here. So for now, let's
just grab this whole first part,
and then we'll adjust it as we
need. And then we'll close it
off. Because we're definitely
gonna need a raffle, we're not
going to need a VRF coordinator
mock because again, we're not
going to be using a mock. Since
we're on an actual test net, we
will need the raffle entrance
fee, we will need Deployer, we
will need a Deployer. And we
might need the interval. But
let's delete it for now we
probably won't need the chain
ID. So let's delete that as
well. Awesome. Something that we
want to keep in mind is that
when it comes to our staging
tests, we only want our steam
test to run when we're on a
test. Net, we don't need to run
our unit tests because our unit
tests aren't checking that
compatibility with a test net,
we want our unit tests to only
run on a local network. And we
want our staging tests to only
run on a test network. This is
where again, in our test, we're
going to check to make sure what
type of chain we're on. And
oops, it looks like I already
imported the development changes
here. So we're actually in our
staging tests, we're going to
check before we run any test
what kind of network we're on.
So we're gonna say, if our
development chains that includes
network dot name, we're gonna
say if our development chains
includes network to name, so if
the chain we're on is in the
development chains, and again,
we're going to use this ternary
operator where we say, if we're
on a development chain, do
something. And then if we're not
something else. If we are on a
development chain, what are we
going to do? Well want to skip
this and we can actually skip
this by putting in this describe
dot skip. And this will skip
this whole section here. And
then we can say, if we are the
development chain, go ahead and
do our thing. So this is some
really nice syntax that allows
us to skip our staging tests if
we're on a local network. And
additionally, we can grab this
syntax, go into our raffle dot
test dot j s where we have our
unit tests and add the bang
operator, which is the knot and
hit Save. And now we're saying
if we're not on a development
chain, skip it and only run this
if we aren't in development
chain. So this says run this
only on a test net or main net.
And then this has run this only
on a local network. Great. So we
have a deployer which we're
going to need. We are not going
to need to deploy any fixtures
because we're going to run our
deploy script and our contracts
should already be deployed. We
will need a raffle we won't need
a VRF coordinator mocks we can
delete that We will need the
entrance fee, and we probably
won't need the interval. So we
can go ahead and delete that
too. Alright, awesome. So we
have our describe, we have our
before each, let's make our
tests. And I'm just going to
make one giant test to test kind
of everything end to end. And
you can add more tests later on
yourself, if you want to our
staging test is going to be
really similar to this massive
test that we made down here. And
in fact, we're going to use most
of this code here as our
boilerplate. So let's create a
describe. And we'll say, and
we'll actually just copy this
describe the four random words
and paste it in here. Because
again, we're going to be using a
lot of the same code in our
staging tests here. Great. So
now we'll say it works with live
chain link keepers and chain
link VRF, we get a random
winner, acing function. So this
is going to be our test in here.
So in this test, we of course,
we want to enter the raffle. And
we shouldn't have to do anything
else except for enter this
raffle. Because the chain the
keepers and the only VRF are
going to be the ones to actually
kick off this lottery for us,
we'll do a quick grabbing of the
starting timestamp to have it
before all this kicks off. So
we'll say const starting
timestamp equals await raffle
dot get last to me get latest
timestamp, get latest timestamp,
we're gonna grab this because
later on, we're going to test to
see if the timestamp has indeed
moved forward, we want to enter
the lottery, right, we want to
run the command we've been
running over here all the time,
we want to do you know await
raffle dot enter raffle, but we
don't want to call it yet.
Because same as what we did over
here, we want to set up our
listener first. Now in here, we
probably should have set up our
listener before we entered the
raffle. However, we controlled
the blockchain. So putting it in
that order was is was okay. But
we want to set up the listener
before we enter the raffle just
in case the blockchain moves
really fast. And we're going to
set up the listener the exact
same way, we did it over here.
So we're gonna say await new
promise. And it's going to be an
async function that takes a
resolve and a reject. And we're
going to use a little arrow
notation here. And in here,
we're going to set up the
listener, we're gonna say raffle
dot once, once that winner is
picked, we're going to do
another async function using
that Arrow.
Arrow function syntax, we'll say
console dot log winner picked
the event fired. And only once
we get this winner picked, can
we start doing our asserts in
here, can we start making sure
that there's a winner, there's a
verifiably random winner, it's
been picked, the money has been
moved, etc. This is where we'll
do our try catch. And if there's
any error, we're just going to
automatically reject, we're
going to reject the promise. And
if all goes well, of course,
we're going to resolve the
promise. So our listener has
been set up here. We haven't
added our asserts here. But we
will, let's just go ahead and
write the rest of the test. And
then we'll go back and we'll
update this listener so so our
listener has been added. And
inside here is actually where
we're going to enter the raffle.
So inside here, await, raffle
dot enter raffle value is going
to be raffle entrance fee. And
really that's it. Right? So
we're setting up the listener,
setting up the listener, then
entering the raffle. And this
code won't complete until our
listener has finished listening
because again, this whole SEC is
in a wait. So we're gonna say
okay, cool setup, the listener,
wait for this to finish. And
then when it gets here, it goes
out okay, this is the end of the
code Are we all done executing
Oh, no resolve or reject hasn't
been called yet. And that's
because we're still waiting for
the listener to finish
listening. Now, once we get this
winner picked event emitted in
here, we're going to get that
recent winner so we'll say const
recent winner equals await
raffle dot get recent winner
will get the raffle state we'll
say const. raffle state equals
await raffle dot get raffle
state, we'll get the winners
balance. So we'll say const.
Winner balance equals await
recent winner. And since we're
only entering with our Deployer
we should check to see the
deployers balance at the end and
we can't do it right with this
deployer object here. So we'll
have to do the player account
equals await ethers dot get
signers, no wrap this actually
actually will just say this is
accounts here like that. And
then we'll just do a count of
zero because it counts as zero
is going to be our Deployer. So
our winner balance is going to
be accounts a zero dot get
balance. And then we're going to
do const ending timestamp equals
a weight raffle dot get latest
To timestamp, and we should also
get the starting balance. So
we'll say winner ending balance,
we should also get the starting
balance right after we enter. So
we'll say const. Winner,
starting balance equals await
accounts. Zero dot get balance,
so that now we can do some
comparisons. All right, great.
Let's do the comparisons now. So
we should first expect the
raffle to be reset. So we can do
this a few different ways. Down
here. We did number of players.
We can also say, await, expect
raffle dot get player 0.2 dot v
dot reverted, right because Get
Player zero should get reverted
because there's not even going
to be an object at zero. So
that's another way we can check
to see if our players array has
been reset. Next, we can do
assert dot equal recent
winner.to string, this should
equal our account zero dot
address. Okay, our Deployer What
else can we do? We will assert
dot equal raffle state to zero.
We want this email to go back to
open after we're done. And then
we finally want to make sure
that the money has been
transferred correctly. So we'll
do assert dot equal, this should
be a winner ending balance. That
to string should be equal to
winner starting balance, add
raffle entrance fee.to string.
So if we look down here, they
enter the raffle we check their
starting balance right after
they enter. And they basically
should just get that raffle
entrance fee back right because
they are the only ones who have
entered this raffle. And then we
can do one more assert, do
assert that the ending timestamp
is greater than the starting
timestamp. And then we'll of
course, say resolve. So this all
goes well, we resolve. If
there's an issue with any of
these asserts, we're going to
catch those errors and we're
going to reject and this is
going to be false. And this
whole test is gonna go ah, there
was an issue, we now have a
staging test that looks really
good here. Let's try
this out. Let's try our staging
test out from start to finish.
So now in order for us to test
this staging test, from end to
end, you first going to need to
get our sub ID for the
channeling fear F then we're
going to need to deploy our
contract using the sub ID, we're
going to need to register the
contract with chain link VRF.
And it's somebody we're going to
then need to register it with
chain link keepers. And then of
course, we're going to run the
staging tests. So let's do it.
So first thing we're going to
need to do is what? Get our sub
ID for chain link VRF. Okay,
great. So we're going to come
over to VRF dot chain dot link.
And we're going to need to
create a new subscription. If we
don't have enough rink B eath.
Let's we want to head over to
the full blockchain solidity
course, here, we're going to
scroll down. And we're going to
look for the recommended test
and here, which is ranked v. And
we're going to use the faucets
link to get some Rigby link, run
Fosses dot chain dot link, let's
switch over from COVID to a
cerium. Rigby, we know we're
going to need some link and some
eath. So let's just go ahead and
get both. Alright, great now
that our transaction has gone
through, let's just double check
our wallet here. And it looks
like we do indeed have Ethereum
here. And if you don't see the
link, you can head over to link
token contracts, Link token
contracts in the chain link
documentation. We'll scroll down
to Rigby, we'll grab this
contract address import tokens
and we'll paste it in here. Add
Custom tokens, import tokens.
Great. Now I can see my eath and
my link here, perfect. We have
some eath we have some link,
let's head over to V REF
subscription management. And
we're going to create a new
subscription. Again, we could
totally do this
programmatically, because the
user interface here is only
helping us facilitate call
contracts to the registration
contract that's completely
decentralized and on chain. So
let's go ahead and create
subscription will create
subscription will confirm the
transaction and Metamask on the
Rinkeby network will do a little
bit of wading in great once it's
gone through, you can go ahead
and click the add funds button.
I'm going to show you what it
looks like if you accidentally
refresh and jump off though. So
if you refresh and you go back
to veer off the chain dot link,
you should have a new active
subscription. And you'll see
this number here. If you click
on it, this is your subscription
ID great. So we can actually
take this, come back to our code
into our helper Hardhead config.
And we can paste our
subscription ID under
subscription ID for our Rinkeby
network here. Awesome. Now that
we have a subscription we can
see it's not funded with any
link. So we don't have any
Oracle gas here. And we don't
have any consumers. Right our
consumer is going to be a raffle
or a lottery contract. So let's
add some funds first and we
don't need to add A whole lot
because we're only going to be
testing once. So let's go just
go ahead and add to link here,
this number might change
depending on different costs of
the test nets and how much link
token there's available. So if
you're actually working on a
main net, be sure to head over
Doc's touching that link EVM
chains contract addresses, you
can read more about the costs
some of these different chains,
so you can figure out exactly
how much to put in here. And if
you go to the full blockchain
solidity course, Jas, we can
scroll down to Lesson Nine,
there's a recommended link
amounts or rinky saving tests
for chain link VRF. For now
we're going to put two for
keepers, we're going to put
eight, but feel free to refer to
here so you know how much to put
in. So let's go ahead and
confirm, we're going to approve
adding funds here, go ahead and
confirm. And we're now funding
our subscription to so we can
pay that Oracle gas to get our
random numbers. Great. And once
we're funded, we can close it,
we'll do a little refresh. And
we can see the balance is now to
link when we don't have any
consumers perfect. So we've got
our sub ID, we funded it. Now
let's go ahead and deploy our
contract. And we already know
that we should be all good for
deploying our contract, we go to
our Dotty and V will need to add
all of those same parameters
from our previous projects,
we'll need to shrink the RPC
URL, we'll need our private key.
If we want to verify we'll need
our ether scan API key. And if
we want to do gas output, we'll
need our coin market cap API
key. So let's make sure we have
all that. And we'll look at our
deploy script. Once again, just
real quick look at our helper
hardcat config just real quick,
and it looks like we do indeed
have everything in here. And we
should just be able to deploy it
in one command.
So we should be able to do yarn,
hard hat or just h h again,
ploy, dash dash network Rinkeby.
Let's go try this out. All
right, it looks like we've
compiled successfully, we've
deployed it successfully. And
we've even verified it, we can
go and open it up on Rinku ether
scan. And we can see our code
here has been verified. And it's
looking beautiful. We can read
from it, which is great. We can
see all these commands here now
that it's verified. And if we
look at the Git raffle state, we
should indeed see that it's
open, right, and it's going to
stay open until somebody ends
the raffle and updates the
amount of eath that the contract
actually has. Now that we've
deployed a contract using that
sub ID, we need to register the
contract with chain link V REF.
And with chain link keepers. So
we need to add this consumer
does tell chinley VRF. Hey, this
is the contract that you're
looking for now. So we're gonna
go back to V REF dot chain dot
link, and we're going to grab
this contract address, and we're
going to add it as a consumer,
your subscription is ready, you
can now add consumers we're
gonna add consumer. And again,
this website is just here to
help facilitate us interacting
with the contract. So we're
going to approve that user,
we'll go ahead and confirm and
the transaction is going
through. While we wait for this
to go through, we can go to
keepers dot chain dot link, and
do the same thing work with the
user interface to register a new
upkeep. So we'll go ahead and
add our email Hardhead free code
camp@gmail.com. We'll call this
raffle upkeep. We'll paste our
upkeep address in here we have
our admin address, and you can
ignore this bit right here. For
gas limit, this is going to be
the gas limit of the PErforM
upkeep function. If we did our
gas estimator, we could just
check to see how much that
perform upkeep costs. But for
now, I'm just going to put
500,000 That's probably
overkill, but that's fine. Check
data, we're going to keep blank
because again, our checkup keep
doesn't take anything. And then
starting balance, we're going to
put as eight. And if you forget
to put a starting balance here,
you can always find it later. So
let's go ahead and register,
we're gonna get a Metamask pop
up, we're gonna go ahead and hit
Confirm. And we can go back to
our VRF and see that it's indeed
been added and awesome, we now
have a consumer on our VRF. So
now let's just wait for our
keepers to go through upkeep
registration requests submitted
successfully on domain net, you
might actually have to wait a
little bit for your request to
go through, but I'll test that
it should automatically go
through. Now if we go back to
keepers dot chain dot link, we
should now see we now if we
scroll down to my upkeeps We
have a raffle upkeep here and I
have to because I accidentally
use the same account that I
tested on, you can ignore the
two you'll have one but this is
the one that we just created.
And we can actually see what our
balances and then what the
minimum balance for this
actually is. So it looks like
eight Link was a little bit too
low. So let's go back to Fosses
dot chain dot link slash rinky.
Now that we have some more link,
we can come back to our raffle
upkeep. And we go ahead and hit
add funds. And we'll add just
three. And we'll go ahead and
confirm we first need to give
permission to spend. We approved
our link transfer now let's
actually transfer the link to
the contract and alright funds
added successfully. So now let's
do a little refresh. Now we no
longer see that message saying
that it's underfunded and we
have our balance and we can see
that it's more than the minimum
balance. We have See the history
that we just funded this twice.
Once this actually kicks off,
we'll see activity type will be
like perform upkeep or something
got our sub ID, we've deployed
the contract, we've registered
with chain link V REF, we've
registered it with chain link
keepers. Now all we need to do
is run the staging tests. Now
running our staging test is
essentially going to be the same
as us calling this enter script,
right, because all we're doing
in our staging test is entering
the lottery. And then we just
have a whole bunch of validators
that we're running to make sure
that things are doing as we
expect, since our contract is
actually verified, what we could
do on Rigby ether scan is we can
actually go to this right
contract section of the
contract. And we could even
connect our wallets to it. And
once this turns from red to
green, after a little refresh,
we'll now see that it's green,
it's connected, we can even call
functions on this contract
ourself, so we could enter the
raffle ourself, we would add,
you know, however much eath to
enter the raffle, and that would
kick off the keepers in the VRF,
as well. So we could call it via
ether scan, we could obviously
call it via our staging tests
here, we could call it via our
scripts, we could call it via
the console, there's a ton of
ways to actually do this. But
moment of truth here, we're
gonna run our staging tests,
which is going to have us enter
the lottery, and set up a
listener to make sure that
everything works correctly. And
additionally, we'll see on our
raffle upkeep history, we'll see
a transaction go through, and
then we'll see a transaction on
our chain like VRF as well. Are
you ready? I sure am.
Let's do this. So we'll do h h,
test, dash dash network, rink B.
And that should be all we need
to do. In our state and tests,
we probably should have added
some console dot logs in here to
tell us hey, to tell us what
steps that we're on with each.
But we forgot to. So if you
follow along with the repo
associated with this, we've
added the console dot logs in
the test there. But all right,
if we go to the ether scan for
this contract, we go back to the
rink the ether scan for this, we
paste in that address, the first
step that we're doing in this
test, of course, while we're
setting up this listener, the
first transaction is going to be
entering the raffle that's going
to kick everything off. Right.
So if we refresh a little bit on
ether scan, we do indeed see
we've entered the raffle. And
we've updated the balance of the
raffle. Okay, awesome. So raffle
has been entered. Now then what
happens? Well, if the raffle has
been entered, if we go to raffle
dot soul, if it's open, if
enough time has passed, if
there's players and it has a
balance, which we just checked
does, this will get kicked off
by the keepers. So if we go to
the keepers, and we do a little
refresh here, after a little
bit, we do indeed see checkup
key passed and we see a perform
upkeep having gone through
great, what does perform upkeep
to well perform upkeep calls the
chainlink VRF. So now if we go
over to chainlink, VRF, we do a
refresh here, go down to
history, we do indeed see one of
the transactions has gone
through we can see the
transaction hash, the link
spent, etc. And now if we go
back to our tests, we do indeed
see raffle unit tests for friend
fulfill random request winner
pick event fired. And this means
that we just went through this
entire process of having a
perfectly truly decentralized
raffle work on an actual
Testament with our integration
tests working correctly.
Absolutely massive, huge
congratulations if you've made
it this far. And if you just
walk through the integration
test with me now bounce over
contract has now been reset to
zero because our wallet address
just won the lottery right and
got the money back. Now you
might be wondering, Hey, I see
the Create raffle function. And
I see enter raffle but I don't
see didn't the chain link nodes
just call perform upkeep and
fulfill random words, I'll come
no matter how often I refresh, I
don't see those transactions
here. Well, those are actually
going to be considered internal
transactions fulfill random
words, it's actually called
through the VRF coordinator and
the VRF coordinator contract
then calls for full randomness.
So we can go to internal
transactions. And one of these
transactions is going to be the
transaction to the VRF
coordinator contract, which
calls our contract. Same thing
with perform upkeep. Perform
upkeep, the chain link nodes
actually call through the
registry contract and then the
registry contract calls perform
upkeep. That's what we see here.
And if we go through the
internal transactions, we'll see
him there. Now let's look at
this enter raffle as well. And
since we've learned about events
and logs, we can actually go to
the logs section now. And we can
see our log or event being
emitted here we can see the name
raffle, enter, we can see the
topic zero which is going to
identify this entire event. And
then we also see this number
here which is what which is
index topic, one address player
and then there's no data
associated with this right
because we only have index
parameters which again show up
as topics so this is absolutely
phenomenal. Wow, absolutely
massive and we can rerun a unit
test Just by hh test in this
will only run our unit tests.
And we can see that these are
all passing as well, things are
looking fantastic here. And we
have just successfully created a
verifiably random, autonomous,
decentralized, raffle and or
lottery deployed on the
blockchain, you should be so
excited right now. Now, I'm not
going to show you how to push
this up to GitHub. However, if
you want to push this up to get
up, and again, tweet at me,
tweet at chainlink tweet at Free
Code Camp, please feel free to
do so because you just did an
amazing job getting this far.
And if you're gonna want to push
this up to GitHub, remember,
we're going to want to put a dot
Git ignore. In here, we add a
ton of stuff like that VS code
artifacts, cash deployments,
known modules, etc. Type chain
types, all this stuff, you can
find a sample dot Git ignore, of
course, in the GitHub repo
associated with this, this is an
advanced project, we did a lot
of really advanced things here.
And this is the section of the
course, where I think at this
point, you've got most of the
fundamentals down. And now we're
going to move into more front
end. And we're going to move
into more industry specific and
more advanced topics that are
really going to supercharge you
and make you one of the masters
of the blockchain in the smart
contract realm. So huge
congratulations, one more time,
definitely go celebrate,
definitely go for that walk,
take a quick break, let
everything we just learned
settling your brain and get
ready for the next one.
Alright, now we're gonna go over
the TypeScript edition of this
lesson, we're gonna go a little
bit quickly here, because we're
not learning too much new stuff
for this TypeScript edition. So
if you want to just follow
along, you can open up the repo
here and use the TypeScript
branch. One thing to note that
is a little bit different is
when we do our promise in our
tests, we're doing a weight
promise void, because we're not
going to be returning anything
with our promise here. But the
rest is going to be exactly the
same. We're going to have a hard
hat dot config to TypeScript
that's going to use imports.
Once again, everything else is
pretty much the same. We're
going to export the config like
we did last time. In our package
dot JSON. Of course, we're going
to have all of our TypeScript
dependencies as well. And then
our deploy scripts are going to
follow that same functionality
that we've used before. So now
our deploy scripts use a type
deploy function on our variables
that we export at the bottom.
And we also import the hard hat
runtime environment type, which
where we pull the deployments
get named account and networks
from in our tests. Of course,
we're still importing the types
of these contracts from type
chain slash types, like you see
here, like for example, raffle
is going to be signed to raffle
VRF coordinator V to mock is
going to be signed to type VRF
coordinator V to MK and if we
wanted to deploy with these
contract factories, we could as
well. So those are going to be
the main differences with
TypeScript. There's not anything
really new there. But again, if
you want to follow along with
TypeScript, and you want to code
everything in TypeScript, and
example is here for you
All right, welcome back. I hope
your break was absolutely
fantastic because now we are
getting into more advanced full
stack slash front end
development. We've done the back
end development, we've created
smart contracts, we created our
lottery. In our last section, we
have all this wonderful code
that allows us to work with our
own provably decentralized
lottery. In order for regular
everyday people to use our
lottery, we're going to need to
build a front end. Now
previously, we learned to build
a front end with raw HTML
JavaScript, with our Funmi
project, we created a front end
with just pure HTML and
JavaScript, just creating
applications with HTML and
JavaScript is great. And if
that's what you want to do, you
absolutely can. But doing it
with those vanilla protocols has
some limitations. And working
with a framework, like what
we're going to be working with
in this section is going to make
our lives a lot easier, we're
going to be able to develop
quicker, have more
functionality, and do more in
less time. As you remember back
to the project wasn't really a
fleshed out project, if you
remember, it was just a bunch of
buttons. And that was really it.
So working with a framework is
really going to enable us to put
more features and add more
styling to our applications
really easy. Once again, the
code for this entire section is
located in our lesson and is
located in this GitHub
repository associated with the
course. Now I have to put an
asterisk here, as I've said many
times, the front end sections of
this course are not required,
we're not going to learn
anything new about the back end
in this front end section. So if
you don't care about building
websites, all you want to do is
learn the smart contract aspect
of this course, you can skip
these sections. But if you do
want to learn how to build these
front end applications, if you
do want to give users and non
developers the abilities to
interact with our smart
contracts, then please continue
to watch. Now I also have to put
an asterix here, because if you
haven't worked with some of
these frameworks before, the
learning curve can seem a little
bit steep. And as I've said many
times, this isn't going to be a
front end course that would take
several more hours than what we
want to do for this video. So if
you've never done front end
before, this is one of the
sections where I do recommend
you follow along with one of
these optional sub lessons,
we're not going to play them
here. But if you follow along
with one of these sub lessons,
that will definitely be
incredibly helpful. One of the
videos that I have for the sub
lessons is this video right
here, how to connect your smart
contracts to Metamask. And it
shows a number of ways
connecting your smart contracts
and building kind of these these
front ends. It does start with a
raw HTML and JavaScript edition.
So you can really get some more
practice in here with HTML and
JavaScript. And then it moves to
index js ethers and a few other
next Jas based applications.
Doing it a few different ways
will install a new some more
insight on what you should be
thinking about when you're
approaching these. So this is
absolutely a video to watch if
you're new to front end
development. Additionally, for
this section, like I said, we're
going to be using a framework.
And in particular, we're going
to be using the next Jas
framework. Now. Next, Jas is a
react based framework. React is
a framework for building front
end and full stack applications.
Next, Jas is a framework on top
of the React framework. So if
you already know react, most of
this is going to come very
naturally to the reason that
we're using React in next Jas is
because React is easily as of
right now one of the most
popular frameworks and languages
out there. And it's no surprise
why we've got a little article
in the GitHub repo titled Why
you should use React js for web
development, which we'll go into
a little bit more. Some of the
biggest applications like
Facebook and Instagram use React
js and a number of other Fortune
500 companies and React js
especially in the blockchain
space is easily the most popular
with protocols like uniswap, and
Avi also using React Jas. Now
the reason we're using this next
Jas on top of React Jas is that
next Jas, I think makes working
with react much easier. And I
want us to work with the easiest
and most powerful framework out
there. Next, Jas is also getting
a ton of steam has some really
advanced but in my mind easier
to use features than just raw
react. Now, like I said, if
you've never worked with React
before, if you've never worked
with next Jas before, and you
want to do a little brush up,
definitely watch my video six
ways to connect your depth to a
wallet. And if you find yourself
struggling with with this
section, because the front end
stuff doesn't really make sense.
We also have a next Jas crash
course in the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
It's about an hour long and it
is absolutely phenomenal. Free
Code Camp also has some next Jas
crash courses. So if you're
struggling with the front of it,
go take it next Jas course, and
then come back to this section
or skip the front end sections
all together, do the rest of the
course of just the back end, and
then come back and do these
front end sections. We're going
to show you the cutting edge
ways to interact and work with
your front end and then also
deploy them. And if you follow
along correctly, by the end of
this, you'll have a website
deployed that you can show off
and you can send a link of it to
your friends. And now I know we
already showed you what this
looks like but I'm going to show
you it one more time just so we
can walk through and see exactly
what we're doing. So we're going
to have this decentralized
lottery where we can go ahead
with can connect our wallet if
not already connected. And we
can switch, we can switch around
between networks. And our app
will actually recognize it and
say, hey, the only supported
chains that we're working with
here are going to be 31337,
which is localhost, or four,
which is ring feed. And we'll
learn how to add this validation
into our application so that our
app only works when we're on a
chain that we want, then we can
go ahead and interact with it.
Normally, we can click a button
Metamask will pop up, we can go
ahead and confirm we'll get a
little transaction notification
saying that transaction is
complete. And we'll get our
front end updated. And then on
the back end, we'll be able to
see the chain link nodes and the
Chinuch V REF do their work. And
once they actually pick a
winner, after a refresh, we'll
be able to see that the back end
node was updated, we do indeed
have a previous winner. Awesome.
Now, not only that, we're going
to show you how to build this,
but also, we're going to show
you how to host it on an actual
site. So you'll be able to push
it up to your own blockchain.
And additionally, we're gonna
host it in a decentralized
context. So this site that we
have here is it's going to be
hosted on a technology that
allows us to host websites in
decentralized contexts as well
swore backends. And even our
front ends can be hosted in
decentralized context. So So I
hope you're incredibly excited
for this because we're going to
be showing you the cutting edge
tools that many of the top
blockchain projects use. And
let's just jump right into it.
Now, I'm currently in the
Hardhead smart contract lottery
project, the project that we
just did, we did this hard hat
smart contract lottery, which is
great. What we're going to do
now is we're going to create a
new folder, although we are
going to be coming back to this
folder from time to time to make
a couple of updates. So if you
want to keep it open, you
absolutely can. But for me, I'm
gonna go ahead and CD download
directory to kind of my main
directory for this whole course.
And we're going to create a new
directory called next Jas. smart
contract. Lottery, FCC, then
we're going to cd into next Jas
smart contract lottery FCC, and
go ahead and hit code period.
And like I said, if you want to
keep that one up and have this
new folder up, you absolutely
can. But basically, again, we're
just opening up our VS code in
this next Jas smart contract
lottery folder. Now for this
front end stuff, in particular,
if you want to be absolutely
sure you're using the same
versions as I am, what you can
do is you can git clone this
repo, and then copy the yarn dot
lock and package dot JSON, and
then run yarn, this will make
sure you're always using the
exact same packages that I'm
using, and you'll never run into
any weird issues. So if you do
run into an issue, one of the
first things to do, especially
for these front end parts is to
go back, make sure you have the
exact same yarn dot lock and
package that JSON that I do in
my examples here, and go from
there. Now we're here in our
front end project. And we're
going to create a website, we're
gonna create a front end for
application, like I said, we're
gonna be using next Jas, if you
want to follow along with the
next Jas documentation here,
they do have a great getting
started and walking through
this. So for us, we're going to
do yarn, create next app, and
then put a little period saying
we want our next app in this
directory. If you don't put this
period, it'll create it in a new
folder, and you'll have double
folders. Okay, awesome. So and
once we do this, in our little
files explorer section, we now
can see all the different files
that come boilerplate with this.
Now, let me just do a quick
walkthrough of what's going on
here. Again, we also go through
this in those two videos that I
recommended, but it doesn't hurt
to go over it twice. So node
modules, of course, is going to
be the package in the
installations pages is going to
be the different pages on our
site. Let me let me show you
what I mean by this. To run this
whole thing. Actually, we can
just run yarn, run Dev, and
we'll get started server on
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
you can command click it or copy
paste it into your browser. And
now you'll see on localhost
3000, we have our page up here.
Now what we can do, actually, so
index.js is going to be our
default page, which is, you
know, considered this slash
here. But what we can do is we
can create new pages. So I could
do new file, you know, dog dot
Jas. And then you know, just
copy paste index into dog to
Jas, paste it, delete everything
inside the div, you don't have
to follow along here and just go
Hi, save this, go back here. I
can now put in dog and get this.
So pages is going to be all kind
of these different routes to
these different spots on our
website. And index is going to
be our default, kind of like our
homepage. So I'm going to delete
Dardo. And inside these files is
going to be something called
react syntax or JSX. They come
as Jas but they're basically
reacts in text. Next, Jas is
based on React, you'll see these
pages are this weird combination
of both JavaScript and HTML. We
see some import stuff at this at
the top, which reminds us of
JavaScript and again, you'll see
some important stuff at the top
and then down here, you'll See,
like div head main h1 P, you'll
see all these like HTML tags
react index js allow us to do
this combination of JavaScript
and HTML. And it actually makes
life a lot easier. Now, you'll
also notice we're doing imports
in here. Remember, I told you
all this earlier, imports work
with our front end require does
not. So that's some of the
difference between node does not
equal JavaScript, right? This is
where the differences can start
getting a little bit confusing.
But the way that I usually like
to think about it is I just say,
no JS, excuse me, I'll just say
back end. I can J S is a little
different from front end. Yes.
So back end, Jas and front end
Jas are a little bit different.
That's kind of the way I like to
think about it. app.js is going
to be our entry point for
everything the way react and
next Jas work is everything is
what's called component based in
all of our files here, you're
gonna see this export default
function home or something along
those lines. What react and next
Jas do is they say, Hey, this
huge clump of HTML stuff that
has a hodgepodge of JavaScript
inside of it is considered a
component. And so all of our
pages get wrapped through this
underscore app.js page. So this
is a page but it's kind of like
the main entry point. And they
get stuck into this component
section of our app that Jas so
you can think of this on this
graph. The GS is kind of the
whole application or whole front
end. And on this homepage, this
component, we're sticking index
dot j s right in here, we're
swapping out component for index
dot J. S. Now API is what we
wanted to do if we wanted to do
like some HTTP, GET HTTP POST
requests, but we're not going to
do any of that. So we're going
to pretty much ignore API for
now public is just going to be
some public images like a
favicon or Versaille, that SVG
styles is going to be the CSS
for our project. CSS stands for
Cascading Style Sheets. And it's
basically a way to style your
HTML, we're going to change the
way we do styling and a little
bit, but that's basically what
these both do the ESLint I'm
dumping this right now we have
our dot Git ignore which we know
what it does. We have our next
dot config dot J. S. This is a
configuration file or next. Jas,
of course, we have our package
json, we have a readme, and we
have our yarn dot lock. So most
of what we're going to do is
actually going to be inside this
Pages folder. And we're also
going to create a couple other
folders that are going to be our
main stuff now, because I'm me,
and like I said, I love working
with prettier, I'm going to
automatically dump a prettier
RC, and a prettier ignore in
here, just so that I can format
my code a little bit nicer, you
can grab your prettier RC from
our last projects, you can grab
your prettier ignore as well. Or
you can just pause me right now
copy, paste them from the GitHub
repo associated with this
lesson, paste them in, and then
we'll do yarn, add dash dash
Dev, prettier, so that we can
auto format all of our code for
come back over to here, we can
save and boom, stuff gets auto
formatted. Now, again, we're
going to be using the multi
terminal feature. So right now I
have one running my front end.
So if I come back to the front
end, I hit refresh. It's still
running. And then I have one to
do, you know my scripts and
stuff. We have yarn run dev
running right now. And if we go
to our package, JSON, running
yarn, run dev just runs next
Dev. And actually, let me cancel
it and just do yarn dev yarn is
actually smart enough that don't
need to do run Dev, but it just
runs next Dev. And this next
command comes built in once we
installed next, which we did
when we did yarn create next
app. So next Jas comes with
these scripts already built in
for us, we want to build our
front end to enable people to
interact with our lottery in a
fair way, and connect with the
smart contract that's running.
Let's create some simple front
end pieces for this. So first
thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna go to Pages, and we're
going to go to index.js. All
this stuff in here is cute and
nice. And thank you next, Jas,
but we're going to delete it all
and delete everything except for
that headpiece, we're gonna
leave that up, we're just going
to change the name. But this way
down here, we're going to change
the name from Crate next app to
smart contract lottery or raffle
or whatever we want to do.
description will be our smart
contract, lottery. And then
right below the head, we're
going to write hello, blue, and
save. And if we look at our
front end, we now see that it
says smart contract lottery and
the top and I'm going to move
this all the way over here,
smart contract lottery and the
top and we see Hello, so smart
contract lottery. Hello, the
description here, we're not
going to see this is going to be
something that web scrapers and
stuff we're going to find.
Now one of the first things that
we're going to need to do is
we're going to need to create
that connect button. We've done
this in the past with raw
JavaScript, but now we're going
to do it with next js and react.
The one that we made previously
was pretty minimalistic. In
fact, we bring it back up it
checked to see if there was
windows that Aetherium and then
went and requested and connected
and said okay, cool. You're
connected. Now what did didn't
do was a lot of things that we
would want an application to do.
When we change networks, our
application didn't detect that
when we change users or
it was really stringent in the
functionality that it actually
had for connecting to a wallet.
So we're going to make our
wallet connect button,
incredibly powerful, so that you
can connect with the button, you
can switch networks, you can
switch accounts, you can pretty
much do anything in our
application will know our
application will be responsive.
So that's gonna be one of the
first things that we're going to
do, we're going to create a
header and connect button nav
bar one a little navbar here,
saying, hey, you know, you can
connect with this button. So
that's gonna be the first thing
that we're going to do. Now we
can build our whole connect
button in this index dot j s and
stick it in here. But instead,
what we're going to do is we're
going to make it a what's called
a component. So we're going to
create a new folder called
components. And we're going to
create a new file in here called
header.js. And you might also
see a lot of people do
header.js x.js and.js x do
literally the exact same thing,
you can do either one, I'm going
to do dot JSX, just to remind me
that this is a React file that
we're creating. This is a
component that we're creating.
But yeah, you can do J S JSX. If
you want to learn a little bit
more about components, we've got
a link to learning about
components. They're basically
independent and reusable bits of
code. They serve the same
purpose as JavaScript functions,
but work in isolation and return
HTML. So basically, we're going
to create like a little chunk of
HTML that we're going to export
into our index such as like what
we've done in the past, this
just helps modularize and reuse
this header component, you know,
across our project. Now, we're
only going to be using our
header in one area. However,
it's still nice to modularize
the project regardless. And to
get start, this is going to be
what's called a functional base
component. So we're going to
create basically a function
called home write really pretty
much exactly like what we see in
JavaScript, except it's going to
return some HTML. So we can do
like a little div. And my VS
code auto created the closing
div here. And in here, I'm going
to be like hi from header. This
is going to be a real
minimalistic component like this
is a valid component here. Now
we have this function that
returns HTML. And to give other
applications, the ability to use
this component will do export
default function home. And then
in our index.js, we can import
it with imports. Home actually,
excuse me, I'm not going to call
it home, we're going to call it
header, header, excuse me,
export default function header,
and then import header from the
down directory components slash
header, like so. So now we've
imported our header in index
such as if we go back to our
front end, which is still
running, we don't see it in
here, right? Remember,
everything goes through our app.
And when we're on the slash
page, that's going to go to our
index.js. index js is importing
our header, but it's not
returning our header, right, we
see. And here, we see it
returns. And this is the HTML
that it's returning. And as you
can see, there's clearly no
header in here. So now that
we've imported our header, we
need to actually add our header
in here. So we'll do header, and
then adds the closing tag right
here. If you don't add any
stuff, you know, in between two
tags, you can go ahead and just
do this one liner here, with a
backslash at the end saying,
Hey, this is an open and closed
tag here. Now that we've
imported it, what do you think
we'll see on the front end, now
that we've added it to our index
js, you're right, we see hi from
header, because we added our
header here. And then we see
Hello. So high from header,
hello, boom. Now, anything that
we do, obviously now in our
header.js, will see reflected on
our front end. So we can do hi
from header, blah, blah, blah,
you know, just a bunch of
dribbles, and we'll see it on
our front end. So this is going
to be our section where we're
going to make our header or a
navbar or all the functionality
for the Connect button. Now I'm
going to tell you something, and
some of you are going to love
this summer, you're going to
hate this. I'm going to show
you. I'm going to show you the
hard way first, then the easy
way. Why am I going to show you
the hard way first? Well,
because I want you to become
familiar with what's actually
going on behind the scenes and
what's actually going on with
some of these components because
it is really helpful when
building these front ends to
understand, Okay, here's what's
going on. If you don't
understand what's going on
behind the scenes, you're gonna
go to try to build more advanced
applications, and you're gonna
have no idea what to do because
you've just learned the
shortcut. I like to think of it
as like calculus, like we're
going to learn how to calculate
a derivative first, and then
we're going to learn the
shortcut to quickly getting
derivatives. So don't skip this
part, because this is going to
help you well and beyond down
the line. Okay, we're going to
learn this the harder way to set
everything up in our HTML Funmi.
We just use raw ethers to kind
of do everything and you
absolutely can use raw ethers to
do everything. However, there
are some packages especially for
React that make life developing
a front end substantially better
and in our full blockchain
solidity course, Jas. We have a
number of other packages that
you can use will stack
development and other libraries.
And if you watch this six ways
to connect your depth to a
wallet, you'll actually
understand some of the
differences. So if you haven't
watched that video, go back,
watch that video. But there's a
whole bunch of libraries that we
can use that are going to make
our lives a lot easier. We've
listed some of them here. React
Morales is the one that we're
going to be using today, they
have some additional plugins,
and they have probably my
favorite thing on the planet,
which I'm going to show you how
to do very soon. But these are
also open source, Ross also
comes with some optional
functionality to hook into your
own back end to give your app
even more features and even more
functionality. And that's the
other reason that we're doing
it. So and we're gonna go over
that later. And if you want to
use pure ethers, you absolutely
still can. A lot of these
packages that we're using do
rely on ethers, but we're not
going to use just ether. So we
go to the React Morales page.
And to get started, we can just
do this bit right here. So we're
literally going to copy this and
bring it into our project. And
if you go to our package that
JSON, we actually already have
react and react DOM. So we can
just do yarn, add Morales, and
react oralis. Now you'll notice
I'm not doing these as dev
dependencies, I didn't do yarn,
add dash dash dev here. The
reason is, because for our
production builds, when we
actually create the website
here, you will need Morales and
you will need react Morales we
don't need prettier to create a
website prettier is a tool that
we're using as developers. So in
all of our projects, so far,
we've been using just dev
dependencies. That's because
we've only been building our
projects for developers, our
GitHub repos, they haven't been
made to build a website, they've
only been to do things on the
back end, for our website, we're
actually going to be building a
front end. So we need to put
this in the dependencies
section, because we need to say,
Hey, these are the ones that we
need to bundle up together for
the front end, and you can
ignore these ones. And if it's
just like a tool to make our
lives better, it's gonna go in
dev dependencies. So we're
adding Morales and react
Morales. And a lot of the syntax
that we're going to do for our
header is actually going to be
really similar to what we've
been seeing so far. So let's do
this. And then actually, we're
just going to change this name
to manual header, manual header
update imports for manual
header, you can go ahead and hit
yes to man you all header here,
we're gonna copy manual header,
make sure it's in our index.js
it we're gonna change header to
manual header, and we're gonna
change how to manual header
here. And the reason we're doing
this is because like I said,
we're going to create a much
simpler header after we create
this kind of harder one. And
we're going to want to create
that connect button, which
again, we made in HTML Funmi. By
calling eath request accounts,
what we can do actually with
Morales is we can just do this
thing called Enable Web three.
So at the top, we're going to
import, use mirallas.
From react ralis. And if you go
to the React Morales page here
or to their GitHub, you'll learn
how to set all this up too and
learn more about the
documentation. So we're going to
import use Morales from react
Morales, and inside our function
here, but outside of our return,
we're going to say const, Enable
Web three equals use mirallas.
Now use Morales is what's known
as a hook as a React hook. And
it's a way to keep track of
state in our application. Now,
in order to use mirallas, our
entire application needs to be
wrapped around what's called a
Morales provider, which is going
to be a context provider for us.
And I'll explain what that means
in a minute. But basically, what
we need to do is we need to add
this Morales provider to our
app.js. So in here, we're going
to import oralis provider from
react oralis. And we're going to
wrap our entire app around this
Morales provided so we're going
to do some little parentheses
here. New Line, we're going to
paste morass provider like this,
it's going to give us the
closing tag, copy it, paste it
like this and save. And then in
here, we're going to write in
the sheet allies on Mount equals
false. This initialize on Mount
piece here is the optionality to
hook into a server to add some
more features to our website. We
don't want to hook into a server
for this application, we want
everything just to be open
source, and we don't need any of
this additional functionality.
So we're just going to do
initialize on Mount equals
false. Now that the whole thing
is wrapped in this Morales
provider, we go to the front end
we should be able to refresh
everything looks pretty much the
same. And we can start using
these hooks. Now this use
Morales is what's known as a
hook and hooks can be a little
bit confusing to understand at
first glance, but they're
incredibly powerful and they are
the de facto way for us to build
react projects. And if you're
familiar with class components,
we're not gonna be using class
components because hooks are
much better hooks allow function
components to have access to
state and other react feature
ers state being probably one of
the biggest ones and the most
popular ones, we want our
application to be different if
we're connected to Metamask,
versus if we're not, right, if
we go back, if we go back to our
example website here, right, if
we're not connected, we want to
say, Please connect to a wallet.
And then when we are connected,
we want to go ahead and be
connected. If I have, let's say,
I have some variable like, and I
don't have this hook here, I
have like, let connected equals
false, right, or enable Web
three, or is web three enabled,
let's say I've led connected
equals false. And then I have,
you know, let's say have some
button that connects us and
changes connected to be true,
changing connected to be true is
great and all but it won't
rerender our application, you
see, when I disconnect and I
reconnect here, our application
actually changes based off of
whether or not we're connected.
And this is what we want, we
want our front end to rerender.
When we're connected, if I just
use a variable like this inside
of our component, our front end
isn't going to rerender. Or even
worse, if I use it outside, our
component doesn't even know
anything about this changing. So
hooks are a way for us to
actually work with state
especially and automatically
rerender when something changes
and enable Web three is going to
be a function that we get from
this use Morales hook to do
that. So for a lot of our
components, instead of just
saying like, let web three
enabled equals true, like we did
in normal JavaScript, we're
going to be doing a lot of this,
these hooks. For the most part,
we usually want our website to
change based off of if some
variable has changed and enabled
web three is a function that we
get from this hook that says,
Okay, go ahead and connect
Enable Web three is basically
the equivalent of saying try
await Aetherium dot request,
like this. Now enable Web three,
the way we're going to use it
here only works on Metamask. But
we will show you how to get this
kind of this cool little module
up where we can choose between
different ways to connect our
app.
We have our enabled web three,
let's go ahead and create a
button, that's going to do the
same as what we did in our HTML
Funmi in our return, but here,
instead of hi friend header,
we're going to add a new
component, or we're going to add
a new tag, we're gonna add the
button tag, and for me it
automatically close to, and I'm
just gonna call it connect, I'm
gonna go ahead and save. Now we
see a little button that says
connect. And obviously, it
doesn't do anything, we're gonna
give this some functionality,
we're gonna say on click now
since again, this is a JSX
component. This isn't raw HTML,
in raw HTML, we can't just kind
of stick JavaScript wherever we
want. But in JSX files, we can
stick JavaScript kind of
wherever we want. So inside of
this, inside of this block of
HTML, we can actually stick
JavaScript in here by adding
these little brackets. So adding
these little brackets in our
jobs can return. But here, we
can add JavaScript. And what we
want to do is we want to have
our On Click Call Enable Web
three, we're going to call an
async function, we're going to
use the arrow syntax here, one
click, we're gonna call this
async function, which is just
going to be await, Enable Web
three, await Enable Web three,
let's add the little parentheses
here. And essentially, with just
this, we've done pretty much
everything that we had back in
this big connect function here.
Now if we go back to our front
end, do a little refresh, we can
see that right now, we can see
that I'm actually connected, I'm
gonna go ahead and disconnect.
I'm still connected from some of
the last applications I was
doing, we can hit Connect, and
now we see metamath does indeed
pop up, we'll hit Next connect,
and boom. And that's all we need
to do. Now, if we look at our
Metamask, it says connected.
Great. Okay, cool. So now we
have a way to actually connect
here, let's add some
functionality and make our
application smart enough to have
the connect button if we're
connected. And if we're not
connected, not have that button.
So what we'll do now is use
Morales comes with another hook
called is web three, enabled,
which is just a variable part of
our hook that keeps track of
whether or not our Metamask is
connected. But we can actually
do one better, we can actually
check to see if there's an
account because maybe web three
is connected. But but they
didn't connect it to an account.
So let's go ahead and we'll
import count from us. Morales
will check to see if there's an
account. So what we'll do is
inside of our div tags, we'll do
a little JavaScript, we'll do
that ternary operator again,
we'll put a count here with a
question mark. And we'll do that
that same syntax that we've seen
before, we'll say account, if
account exists, do this. If
there's no account, do this. And
if there's no account, we want
to add this Connect button. So
we'll go ahead and we'll stick
this in here. If there is an
account, we'll just show that
account, right. So we'll do div
backslash div in here, we'll
just say connected, like that.
Now if we go back to our front
end, we see connected. If we do
a little refresh, it'll go away.
So we'll we'll re hit Connect,
and now we're connected, which
is great. Let's make it even
smarter. We'll have it show our
account here. So instead of just
saying connected, we'll say
connected to I'll put some
JavaScript, we'll put some
JavaScript inside of our
JavaScript. But since this is
that HTML stuff, we got to use
these brackets to say JavaScript
again. So we'll put JavaScript
inside of the JavaScript, we'll
say connected to, we can just
say account. Now go back to our
front end, we see connected to
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
you'll notice if you hit
refresh, you'll have to
reconnect, we'll get to that in
a minute, what a lot of people
do is they'll do a count dot
slice, zero, comma six. And then
outside of the brackets, they'll
do dot that dot, another set of
brackets account, that slice,
count dot length minus four,
close that off like that, we
have our account, when we hit
Connect, now it says connected
to blah, blah, blah, hello. And
because of these hooks, when I
switch accounts, and I connect
with these new accounts, it even
automatically re renders
switching accounts. So these
hooks are really good for re
rendering our websites whenever
some value changes. For example,
if I said like, let count number
equals seven, and we had a
button, that updated account
number, our front end wouldn't
rerender unless we told it
specifically to rerender, which
gets really annoying. So hooks
kind of help us a lot with doing
that. And it allows us to keep
track of states between renders.
Now, here's something that right
now it doesn't do, if I hit
refresh, I have to re hit this
connect button, even though my
Metamask says, Hey, we're
connected. But if I refresh, I
have to re hit this Connect
button. Why is this happening.
Or when I hit refresh, our
website doesn't know that we've
hit enable Web three already,
right, because we basically go
back to blank when I refresh,
and then I have to hit Connect,
which is really obnoxious and
really annoying. So we want to
add some functionality, so that
automatically the instant we
render, we go ahead and we check
to see if we're already
connected. And if we're
connected to show this. Now to
do that, we can use another hook
called use effect. And this is a
core react hook. So we'll do
import use effect from react
like this. This is a core hook
directly from react. And it's
one of the most popular out
there along with use state. And
we've left some links to
learning more about the effect
hook in the GitHub repo
associated with this course, I'm
gonna give you my summary of
basically what this use effect
does, we basically have this
function called use effect,
which takes two parameters, it
takes a function as its first
parameter, and then second, it
optionally takes a dependency
array. And what this use effect
is going to do is it's going to
keep checking the values in this
dependency array. And if
anything in this dependency rate
changes, it's going to call some
function, and then rerender, the
front end. So for example, using
Morales comes with this function
called is web three enabled or
this variable called is what
three enabled. If we add this to
our dependency array, what we
can do in our use effect is do
console dot log, hi. And then we
can do console dot log is web
three enabled, what this use
effect is going to be doing is
it's going to constantly be
running, this is running all the
time. And it's going to be
listening to see if is web three
enabled changes, right? And
anytime we run Enable Web three
is web three enabled becomes
true. So so now if we go to the
front end, we do a little
refresh, we see high false, high
false. Now why do we see this
twice is web three enabled only
changed once? Well, this is
because of how use effect works,
it will automatically run on
load or right or the first time
it does and then it'll run
checking the value. So we're
basically seeing this run twice,
it runs the first time we load
it, and then it'll check the
value and run again. So we see
go twice, even though it's
really just once. But if we go
back here, sorry, let me just do
a quick reload again. We hit
Connect, we now see Hi is now
true, because it saw is what
three enabled change to true
because enabled web three made
is what enabled return true. And
it ran this again, right. So
that's how that actually works.
And there's a couple of
different ways to think about
this. Actually, we actually
don't even need to give this an
array. And what happens if we
don't give this an array? Well,
let's refresh. We'll hit
Connect, and we'll see it's
still ran a couple of times. So
if we don't give it array, no
dependency array, it'll run any
time something re renders. And
you need to be careful with
this. Because then you can get
circular renders, if you have
some use effect that changes
some value. And you have another
use effect that re renders when
that value changes while they're
both just going to keep changing
back and back and forth. So no
dependency array like this. It
will run anytime something re
renders we'll give it a blank
dependency array. It'll just run
once on load, just run one time.
So now like we have a blank
dependency right in here, we
reload. Right? We see that it
runs twice. That's actually
because we're basically re
rendering once in the
background. So it really is just
running Once but there's
something else going on in the
background. So it looks like
it's running twice. Now if we
just add is web three enabled,
do a little refresh, it'll do
the exact same thing, it'll run
the same amount as if this was
blank. But when we connect,
it'll add here. If this was a
blank array, when we refresh,
we'll see kick out twice, which
should be ones. But like I said,
there's something going on in
the background. If we hit
connect. Now, we don't see
anything here, because the blank
dependency array says, Hey, I'm
only going to run one time on
load. Now, if there's our stuff
in this array, like is web three
enabled, it's going to run
anytime something in this array
changes, right. So again, we'll
refresh will connect, we see it
ran again, after a hit Connect
will refresh. Hi, hi connected,
ran one more time. So so that's
kind of the cheat sheet here. If
we give it no dependency array,
it's going to run any time
anything in this project re
renders, if we give it a blank
dependency array, it's just
going to run one time, or like
we saw, it ran twice. But that's
because there's something else
we render in the background. And
if we give it dependencies in
this array, it's going to run
anytime something in this array
changes. And this is really
helpful, because oftentimes,
we're going to want our front
ends to rerender, this use
effect will say, oh, cool, some
value changed, I'm going to run
this function, and then I'm
going to rerender, your front
end.
And now we're going to use this
use effect thing to make sure
that when we refresh, it
remembers that we're actually
connected. So how do we do that
inside here, we are going to use
this is web three enabled thing.
And the first thing that we want
to just do is we want to say if
is what three enabled, then
we'll just return. Because if
we're already connected to web
three, then we don't need to do
anything. Now, if we're not
connected to web three, and we
don't have an account, we'll
want to go ahead and call Enable
Web three, right want to
automatically enable Web three.
So now if I go back, you'll see
with just this code, I'm just
always automatically calling
Enable Web three. But this can
get really annoying. Because if
I disconnect, right, let's go
disconnect everything. Now
refresh, it's going to always
call Enable Web three, right,
every time we refresh, it's
going to automatically call
enabled through without us even
hitting the Connect button. So
that's no good to we want to
actually see if we're connected.
So the way we do this, like I
said, we want to use our local
storage, again, application, or
these little, this little thing
here go to Application, we want
our we want our application to
remember that somebody hit this
connect button, and they went
and connected to us. So what
we're going to do is in our
little onClick function down
here, we're not just going to
call await Enable Web three,
we're also going to store a
little remembrance here saying,
Hey, we actually did connect
recently. So below this, we're
going to run window, dot local
storage, dot set item,
connected, comma injected. I'm
actually going to comment this
out for now, because my friend
is just going to keep popping up
like that. So what this does is
we're saying, okay, in our
window, because again, if you go
back to the window, you go to
console, a type window, you're
actually going to see this giant
window thing here, right, which
we showed you before, there's
always this window object in
here. And we're going to do
window dot local storage, which
relates to if we go to this
application section, this local
storage section here, that set
item connected to inject it. So
we're going to set a new key
value in here, we're doing it
like this because in the future,
maybe you want to do you know
connect it to Wallet connect or
connected to Coinbase wallet or
something, right, but we're just
gonna say injected, meaning
we're connected to that meta
mask. And in some versions of
next, Jas next, Jas has a hard
time knowing about this window
variable. So we can just do if
type of window does not equal
equal, undefined, then we're
going to do this. So we're just
making sure that window doesn't
equal undefined that there is a
window. So now if I go back to
the front end, and I hit
Connect, and we go ahead, and we
connect here, we'll see now in
our application, local storage,
we'll see we've added this
connected injected bit here,
we're storing in the browser
that we are indeed connected to
this. Now that we've added this
into our browser, we can roll
back up to our use effect here
and say, Okay, if they're
already connected, great, we'll
be done. But before we do
anything, let's check to see if
they have this here. And if they
already are connected, let's
just run that connect bit. So
we'll say if type of window does
not equal, undefined, right,
because we want to check for
that window object. Again, we'll
say if window dot local storage
dot get item connected,
connected, so if that connected
key exists, then we'll just run
Enable Web three. So now We have
some functionality in here,
which even when we refresh, it
will automatically run enable of
three for us. So now if I go
ahead and refresh the front end,
we don't have to press that
connect button anymore, because
it goes, Oh, I see that locally,
we stored this connected key
whenever you refresh. Now, it
checks for this first it sees it
and then runs enabled web three.
Now on the other side, though,
if we're in here, and now we
disconnect, and then we refresh.
This will show up, which is
really annoying. And every time
we refresh, it'll keep showing
up, which we don't want. We want
it to be that when we
disconnect, we tell it hey,
we've we've gone ahead and
disconnected here. So back in
our application, we can add
another use effect to check to
see if we've disconnected. So
let's create another use effect.
That's going to costly just look
for us being connected, we'll
say use effect, do a little
arrow bracket thing here. And
we're going to do this anytime.
And oh my goodness, anytime I
save, it's going to keep popping
up. So I'm just going to just
going to comment that out for
now. So in here, we want to say
okay, whatever, there's a
rerender we want to run if any
account has changed. And Morales
has some functionality for us to
do this as well. So from user
morass, we're going to import
more Alice, and then down here
in our use effect. Inside the
little function, we're gonna say
mirallas.on account, changed
of account, we're gonna do some
stuff. So on account changed,
takes a function as an input
parameter. So we'll say console
dot log, account, change to
account. And what we can do is
we can check to see if this
account is not. And we can say
if account equals equals no,
then if the account is null, we
can assume they've disconnected.
So we can say window dot local
storage, dot remove item,
connected, we'll also run a
deactivate web three function.
So from Ross, deactivate, web
three will also run, deactivate
web three, which is going to set
is web three enabled to false.
So we're going to disconnect the
web three, and then we're going
to say console dot log.
No
count found. So let's try this
out. Now. Let's go back to our
front end, we'll do a little
refresh here. So right now it
says we're connected. Even
though in my meta mask, we're
not connected, right? And to
start from scratch here, you can
go ahead and disconnect it. But
but my browser says, Hey, we're
connected, right? So now we'll
connect. And we'll actually be
connected right, next connect,
and it and it just overrode
connected, you know, with
inject, let's, let's make this
injected. And then we'll remove
Yep, okay, injected, we'll
refresh, like, connect, and now
it says injected. Okay, cool. So
now we're connected here. If in
here, if I just switch accounts,
right, let's go to Account
three, I'll connect. If we go
back to our console real quick,
we'll say account change to
blah, blah, blah, I can change
back, right, we'll go change
account change to blah, blah,
blah. Now, if we go back to our
application, go in here. And we
disconnect. Now let's disconnect
both of these disconnect. And
disconnect. We'll see it's now
been removed from local storage.
And if we go to our console,
it'll say, no account, change
the No, no account found and
removed it. Now if I hit
refresh, nothing happens here, I
can go ahead and connect. Right
next connect, I can refresh.
Oops, I need to go back in here
and re enable this. So sorry,
let's add this back in here. But
now it can refresh. Let's go
ahead and disconnect here. Let's
connect. Let's go back to the
console, we can connect thing
will pop up next connect, I can
refresh. It stays connected for
me, I can switch accounts, I can
go ahead and here, I can switch
accounts, I can even disconnect.
And it will automatically update
for me, which is what we want.
So now we've essentially made a
way more robust connect button,
where it goes back and forth
with when we're connected now.
Now one more thing that we might
want to do, or application is
when we hit Connect, we want to
maybe disable this button,
right? We don't want it to allow
it to be able to be pressed. So
I'm gonna hit Cancel, we're just
gonna add one more bit of
functionality here, we're going
to add this is web three enable
loading. And what this does is
it just checks to see if
Metamask has popped up. And so
what our button after the on
click section, we can add
disabled. Equals is web three
enable loading, so it'll be
disabled if we're loading here.
So let's go ahead and we'll
disconnect disconnect. Now we'll
hit Connect, and you'll see the
button can be clicked. So that
just makes it a little bit nice.
Turn, Next connect Bada bing,
bada boom, awesome, we have just
made a way more robust front end
than what we had before this
connect button is super slick.
And it allows us to kind of flip
back and forth. And our
application is incredibly
powerful and knows how to handle
all these different changes. Now
that we've learned how to do it
the manual way, let me give you
the Chiti way, in our
components, we're gonna create a
new file header dot j s, and
what we're going to do is we're
going to install this web three
UI kit, it's a front end kit,
and it has a whole bunch of
these components already built
for us. So we can build like a
header component and a connect
button component just by using
this. So to install, install it,
we're gonna come back here,
we're gonna stop our front end.
And we're just going to run
yarn, add web three UI kit, like
that. And again, we don't want
this to be a dev dependency,
because it is going to be a part
of our website, and then we'll
do in our header.js, we'll do
import connect button from web
three UI kit. And then we'll do
export default function header.
And then all we'll do is return
do like a div. And then inside
this div, we'll do next button.
With a little backslash here, we
aren't going to need this for
this project. But if we want to
be super explicit, we'll say
Morales off equals false. Just
again, to reiterate, hey, we're
not trying to connect to a
server here just to make that
super explicit. But this connect
button does everything, this
manual header thing that we just
created, does. So back in our
index.js, we can comment or
delete this line will do import
header from dot dot slash
components slash header. And
then instead of manual header,
we'll just do header. We start
our app back up with yarn dev
again,
we go back to the page, we do a
little refresh here, we now see
we have this connect Wallet
button. And it's even looks a
lot nicer. It's got some nice
styling to it as well, we can
hit Connect wallet. And it'll
give us this little ngModel
asking us which wallet we want
to connect to. So asking us
which wall we want to connect to
is kind of similar in our manual
header to this or set item
connected, injected, right or
wallet connect, it would do
connected wallet Connect for
trust wallet, it would it would
set item as connected wallet
connect, etc. So it allows us to
connect in different ways. And
we if we hit Metamask, we go
ahead and connect like so even
had some nice styling here where
it gives us our wallet address
here. But it also gives us our
wallet balance as well. And
again, if we go ahead and
disconnect, we'll see it
automatically disconnect. We
connect like so we can reconnect
like so boom, boom. If we switch
accounts, it's smart enough to
know that we're switching
accounts. So I know I showed you
kind of the hard way. But I
wanted to show you kind of
what's going on. It's setting
this local storage in the
background so that it knows
which where it's actually
connected. But for headers
moving forward, this is all you
need. And your life will be
drastically drastically easier.
And let's just add a centralized
lottery or decentralized raffle
or whatever you want to our
header as well. So it says
decentralized lottery, you know
the button Hello. Now that we
have that, what else do we need?
Well, well, the main thing that
this app needs to do is just
have a big button that says
enter the lottery. And then
ideally, you know, show how many
people are in the lottery and
then the recent winner as well.
So let's go ahead, we'll create
a new component called lottery
entrance. And we'll grab that
component similar to like what
we did with our header, we'll
drop this component right here.
And then our app will pretty
much be done. So let's create
this lottery entrance component,
lottery entrance, that Jas,
right and again, in the reason
we're putting these in
components, we could 100% Stick
it all, you know all our code in
here to make it more modular so
that we in the future, if we
want to have more pages or do
other stuff, I'm going to zoom
out a little bit just so that we
can see all of our code a little
bit easier. This is our whole
index j s. This is our whole
header. Let's create a new
lottery entrance app just for
the boilerplate code here we're
going to export default lottery
entrance, excuse me, export
default function, lottery
entrance, and this is just going
to be you know, another
component where we're going to
return some that JSX HTML stuff,
right? So we're gonna do div and
do like hi from lottery
entrance, Excel. And now that we
do that, we can go back to our
index.js. We can do import
lottery entrance from dot dot
slash components. Slash lottery
entrance, will stick it right
underneath the header like that.
And if we go back to our
website, we see high from
lottery entrance so our lottery
entrance is going to be right
underneath the header would
Here's what we want. And then
we'll delete this line that
says, Hello. So lottery
entrance, what is the what is
the first thing that we really
need to do in here? Well, we're
going to want to have a function
to call the lottery to enter the
lottery. Let's go ahead and do
this. Now let's go back to how
we did this with HTML fund me
recall that old fun function
like this, but doing it like
this won't rerender. And there's
a whole lot of other
functionality that doing it like
this won't give us so we're
going to use Morales to actually
call some of these functions,
because mirallas has in React
mirallas. Again, they have hooks
for us to do pretty much
anything we want to do. And one
of these hooks is called use web
three contract. And what this
does is it gives us a hook that
will give us the data returned
from a function called an error
returned, a little function that
we can use to call any function.
And then we also have these
really helpful is fetching in is
loading. So if we want everyone
to have our UI or our website,
do something while it's fetching
or while it's loading the
transaction, we can use these
two variables to do that. And
then all we need to do is we
just need to pass it the
contract information, which
similar to ethers is going to be
the ABI contract address, we'll
pass the function name, and then
any parameters for that
function. So we're going to use
this syntax here to make that
transaction to the blockchain.
And to call these functions. So
what we're going to do is we're
going to import us web three
contract
from react mirallas. And inside
our function, but before I
return, of course, we're going
to say const. And then we'll do
kind of exactly what we see in
here. For now, let's just get
the function, let's just get
this run contract function,
because this is going to be the
function that we can call to
actually enter the lottery. So
we'll say const, run contract
function, and we're actually
going to call this enter raffle.
And we'll say equals, use web
three contract, and we need to
pass the ABI, we're gonna need
to pass the contract address,
we're gonna need to give it the
function name, we'll need to
give it the params, which
actually we do know it's going
to be blank. But then finally,
we will need the message value.
Because if we remember back into
raffle doesn't take any
parameters, all it takes is this
message dot value bit. So that's
all we're going to need to pass.
So how do we get all this stuff,
and I'm going to leave this in
here. But we're going to comment
it out for now, because this is
what we need to do. But we need
to get all of this stuff into
our code here. So how do we
actually get all that stuff?
Well, ABI is easy, right? Abi
isn't going to change at all, no
matter what network or on ABI is
always going to stay the same.
Now if you've already deployed
your smart contracts, and you
know exactly what address it is,
because you've deployed to a
main net, or you've deployed to
a test net, all this stuff isn't
really going to change. And we
can just hard code it all right
into here. Or we can do what a
lot of people do is they'll
create a constants folder. And
in here, they'll add like an API
dot JSON, maybe they'll add a
contract addresses dot JSON. And
then they'll add maybe like an
index dot j s or something,
we're gonna build our
application in a way we can
actually test locally using our
own Hard Hat Network, and then
compare it to what it looks like
on the actual test net as well.
So we're going to make it
network agnostic. So the front
end works exactly the same no
matter what network that we're
on. And we can go back, download
a directory back into our CD,
hard hat smart contract lottery
Free Code Camp, and spin up our
node here, right with hh node or
yarn hard hat node. And we'll
use this as the blockchain that
we're going to connect to. The
thing is, if I go back here, and
I'm building the front end, and
I go, ah, like this would be
better if we did X, Y, or Z. And
maybe I changed the name of some
functions, you know, blah, blah,
blah, something else, I want
that change to be reflected on
my front end. And I want to be
able to code my front end as
such. So since we are the only
developer right now, we kind of
have the ability of where we
both know, the back end code and
the front end code. So something
that I like to do to make my
life a little bit easier is I
like to create an update front
end deploy script. So after we
deploy stuff, we run a little
script that will create this
constants folder for us with a
whole bunch of stuff, right?
It'll give an ABI, it'll give
contract addresses and anything
else we might need in our front
end from our back end. So what I
like to do is I like to come
back to my original code and an
update this for a new script. So
I'll come in here in this deploy
script, I'll create a new file,
and I'll call it oh two or even
like 9999, up, date, front, and
dot Jas. And the reason I do 99,
obviously, is because we want
this to be always the last
script in our deploy folder. And
then we can just write a little
script that's connected. We just
write a little script that's
connected to our front end here
so that whenever we deploy
contracts, no matter what chain,
we can update that constants
folder on our front end. So
let's go ahead and create that
script right now we'll do module
dot exports, equals async
function. And we'll add all our
stuff in here, we don't really
need to deploy any contracts,
because we're just updating the
front end. So we can just leave
the parameters of this one
blank. And the other thing I
like to do, because sometimes I
don't care about the front end,
what I'll do is I'll only update
the front end if we've specified
a dot env variable. So I'll
create a dot env variable called
up date, front end. And then
I'll set this to true. And now
in our script here, we can say
if process dot E and V dot
update, front end. And we can
just say like console dot log,
updating front end. And now back
in here, right, if a mat if I'm
in the correct directory in
here, if our own hard hit
Deploy,
you know, get this little
updating front end. And now we
can update front end. So let's
do it. So I'm actually going to
create one function called
Update contract addresses. And
this is going to be our function
that we're going to use to
update contract addresses, then
I'm going to make one called
Update API, where we just update
the API's and the front end so
so we're going to call this
update contract addresses. So
I'm going to create a new
function async function, update
contract addresses. And first,
we're going to get that raffle
contract since we're going to
need to get its address. So
we're gonna say const, raffle
equals await. And we're gonna do
the same thing we've been doing
ethers dot get contract, raffle,
and then my VS code auto
imported, it doesn't const
ethers equals require Hardhead,
like so. So we have raffle in
here. And we're gonna want to
pass this raffle address to our
front end, since this is going
to be a variable that we might
use a lot of places, we can just
add it like const, front end
location, addresses file,
equals, and we're going to give
it the relative path to where we
are now, which is going to be
you know, if we see the download
directory to next year's smart
contract lottery, FCC, I can
even just copy this, paste that
in here. And then it's in the
constants folder, and it's going
to be contract addresses dot
JSON. And let's get the ABI
file, we'll say const. Front and
a bi file is going to equal and
this is going to be nearly the
same thing. So we can just copy
paste that. And then we'll do
slash API dot JSON. And now in
our update contract addresses
function, we can say const,
current addresses, equals and we
can read again, in our front
end, we can read from this file.
So I'll usually start out with
just two brackets. So that's
like JSON compatible in both of
these files. And so to read it,
we're gonna say JSON dot parse,
FS dot read file sync, we're
gonna have to import, say const.
FS equals require, I know we've
used Fs extra in the past, but
this one, we're just gonna use
Fs, which is going to be our
front and addresses file, we're
going to read it in with UTF
eight encoding. So now this is
going to be our current
addresses. And we're going to
update the list of current
addresses with some new
addresses. Because our contract
addresses we want this to be
chain agnostic, we would do
something like for you know, and
then the addresses on rink B, we
could do 31337, and then the
addresses on our local host,
right, we want to be able to
keep track of all the different
addresses across all the
different chains. So back in our
function here, then we'll say if
if network, dot config dot chain
id.to string in contract
addresses that were config ideas
in there, then we're just gonna
go ahead and add this new
contract address in there. But
before we add this new address
in there, let's just check to
make sure it's not are already
in there. So we're just gonna
say if contract addresses of
network dot config dot chain
id.to string, this is so long, I
don't want to keep writing that
I'm gonna say const chain ID
equals network, config that
chain id.to string, and we're
just gonna use chain ID. If
chain ID and contract address
then if we don't already have
that includes raffle dot
address. We're gonna go ahead
and add this new address and
then if the chain ID doesn't
even exist, we're gonna go ahead
and do contract addresses
current addresses, equals or
assuming current addresses of
chain ID equals and then we'll
just create a new array, raffled
that out address. So we're
saying if the chain ID doesn't
exist in current addresses,
we're just going to add this new
array in there. And then
finally, now that we've updated
its object, we're gonna write it
back to this file, we'll say Fs
dot write, file sync, front and
addresses file. And then we're
gonna do JSON dot string of
five. So we're going to
Stringify this JSON object, so
we're just gonna go ahead and
write it back. And then bottom
module that exports that tags
equals all and then front end. I
cool. So we have a function to
update the contract addresses,
but we also need the ABI. So
we're gonna do date API, and
we're gonna create another
function async function, update
API. And in here, we're gonna do
the exact same thing on raffle
equals await ethers that
contract,
raffle FX dot right file, sync,
front and abi. It's just going
to copy paste it front end, AVI
file. And then to pass just the
ABI, we can actually get it
directly from this raffle
object, we can actually just do
raffle dot interface that format
ethers dot utils, dot format
types, dot JSON. If you look in
the ethers, Docs, ethers has
this contract dot interface
thing which returns an interface
which is different from a
solidity interface. But it
allows us basically just to get
the API with this one line of
code. So in our back end code
here, now if you run h h deploy
or H H node, we should
automatically update our
contract addresses in our API
dot JSON. So let's go and try
this. So we'll run h h node. So
we'll start a node, right in
this terminal over here, we'll
flip back to the front end. And
if we open ABI to JSON, we do
indeed, now see, we have the
raffle API in this file. And if
we go to contract addresses, we
see on network 31337, here's our
first address, right. And if we
deploy to different chains, this
will get populated with
different network IDs, and then
a list of addresses associated
with them. So it helps make our
front ends a lot easier to
maintain, and bounce around and
kind of test and work with. Now
that we've done all this, we can
actually close our hardhat smart
contract lottery Free Code Camp,
the hard hat project for this,
and we're just going to have all
of our terminals be in here. So
what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go down and directory CD
dot dot, and we're going to cd
into Oh, sorry, we're actually
we're already in their CDs, hard
hat, smart contract, lottery
Free Code Camp. And then in this
one, we're going to run hh node
or yarn hardhat node. Now we'll
have a local blockchain running
so we can test everything that
we're doing in the front end,
actually, I'm gonna move this up
one. So now in our first area,
here, we have our front end code
running, then we have our
blockchain running. And then in
this one, we're just going to
add, you know, whatever we want
to add. Now, we can actually go
ahead and hit this little X
button here to close the panel.
So that's just hiding the panel,
these are all still out, they
only get trashed when you
actually hit the little
trashcan. So we're just going to
close the panel. But all those
terminals are still running, I
promise back. So where were we?
Okay, back to our function here.
So we just automated the process
of updating our API's and then
updating our contracts as well.
And now we can import these into
our files. Now we can import
them one at a time, it'd be like
import API, from dot dot slash
constants, slash API, or we
could do something a little bit
clever is we could export these
in the same file. So if we
create a new file, a new
index.js, in here, we can import
them and then export them in
this one file. We can say const,
contract editor says equals
require dot slash contract
editor dot JSON, and then const
API equals require dot slash API
dot JSON. And then we'll do
module dot exports equals API
and contract addresses. So now
once we export them like this
back in our lottery entrance, we
can import them just in one
line. So we'll say import API
comma contract addresses from
dot dot slash constants. So we
can just specify the folder
instead of each individual
files, because we have this
index dot j s here, which
basically represents this whole
folder. Back in here, what do we
have now? Let's uncomment this
abi. Okay, great. We have the
ABI we're importing it from our
constants, folder, contract
addresses, we have our contract
addresses. And we're going to
need to specify the network ID
in just a second here. We have
the function name here, which is
going to be what enter the
raffle. There are no params. So
all we need to do so how do we
get both the chain ID and then
Also the message dot value will
change, it is something that we
can get really easily with
Morales, let's comment this
whole section out one more time,
just so I can show you something
we can do import. Once again,
we're going to get that use
Morales book from react Morales.
And what we can do is we can say
const.
Chain ID equals use ralis. Now,
the reason morality knows about
what chain we're on is because
back in our header component,
the header actually passes up
all the information about the
Metamask to the Morales
provider. And then the Morales
provider passes it down to all
the components inside those
Morales provided tags
concentrated equals use Morales.
And I'm just gonna do a little
console log chain ID because I
want to show you what it looks
like. So if we do a little
refresh, and we're in the
console here, we can ignore some
of these warnings here, but we
see the chain ID is actually 0x
Five, well, because I'm on the
rink B chain or the Grilley
chain excuse me, if I switch
back to hard hat localhost,
which you should know how to do
from a SEMA fun we bet if you
don't have hard hat localhost
and your Metamask go back to
that HTML font we bit follow
that along. Okay, great. Now
it's going to print this Oh x
bla bla bla bla bla. So that
might be a little bit confusing.
But this is the hex version of
our chain ID. Right. So let's
switch to Etherium main net. Now
we pronounce Oh x one, right?
Oh, x one is the hex version of
the number one. So chain ID
gives us the hex addition of the
chain ID. So I don't want the
hex addition, I want the actual
number. So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to say Okay, chain
ID, your name is actually going
to be chain ID hex. And we can
do console dot log chain ID hex,
but I want the number. So what
we can do is parse a built in
JavaScript parse int, CIN ID hex
like that. Now if I go back,
we'll do a little refresh here.
Scroll away from the warning, we
can see the one here. Now let's
switch to hard hat, localhost.
We'll scroll down we see 31337.
So use Morales chain ID returns
the hex we parse it with Parson
to get the actual number. Okay,
great. So we can stick the chain
ID into here. Now this raffle
address is something that we're
actually going to use a lot, we
might as well have it be at the
top of our code here, we aren't
going to be changing the raffle
address. So we don't need to put
it in a hook. We are going to
technically be changing the
address when we change networks.
But our header app takes care of
re rendering and dealing with
all that. So we can just make
this a constant variable. So we
can say const, raffle address
equals, first let's check the
chain ID hex and if there's a
chain ID hex and if there's not
a chain ID hex we're gonna do
something else. Excuse me, we're
gonna say chain ID hex in
contract addresses. And
actually, there's never gonna be
a chain ID hex. So we'll do
const chain ID equals Gen ID hex
parsed, Parsons, chinati hex,
and you might be thinking, hey,
this, these are both the same
name. Well, what we're doing up
here in use Morales is we're
saying hey, pull out the chin ID
object, and then rename it to
chain ID hex and down here,
we're saying, Hey, we're going
to create a new variable called
Chain ID. So we'll say contract
addresses of chain ID at zero.
So in here, we're saying this
network ID and this address,
otherwise, we'll just say no.
Okay, we're getting there. Let's
uncomment this, now we have the
raffle address, and we can just
stick it in here. All we do now
is the message dot value. If we
remember back to our raffle, we
actually set that fee
dynamically. So we have in here
we do entrance fee equals
entrance fee, which is the
parameter in the constructor. So
we want to call this get
entrance fee function. This is
one of the ways we can send a
transaction. And we can also
send functions, one of the ways
that we're going to do it right
when our lottery entrance loads,
we're going to run a function to
read that entrance fee value. So
how do we do that? Well, we can
use one of our hooks again,
right use effect use effect can
run right when something
changes, we're only going to
want to try to get that raffle
entrance fee if web three is
enabled. So what we can do is
back up in here and use Morales
will pull in that is web three
enabled. And we'll have our use
effect in our function, we'll
just say if this is web three
enabled, then we'll try to read.
So we can go ahead and use this
use web three, contract Wagan.
Let's go ahead and just copy
paste this. And we'll use the
same setup here. Except instead
of enter raffle, of course,
we're going to be doing get
entrance fee. So we're going to
get entrance fee. We need the
API we got it raffle address got
it. This is going to be the
function name is going to be get
entrance fee params nothing
message that value, nothing.
We're going to be calling this
get entrance fee function. And
now I finally show you how to
actually call one of these in
our contracts here. Use web
three contract, download our use
effect, we're actually going to
call get entrance fee. Now if we
just call get entrance fee like
this, and we say like, you know,
const something equals get
entrance fee and then console
dot log something, what do you
think's going to happen? And
oops, I need to import, I need
to import use effect from react.
There we go. We look or logs, I
don't see console dot log,
something won't get entrance fee
is going to be an async
function. Once again, we need to
wait we would need to do a wait
get into T, right? There's an
issue we can't call await in our
use effect. So what can we do?
Well, we can actually make an
async function, call it update
UI. And then we can stick this
inside of the async function
here. And we can call update UI
right outside of it like this.
So now we go back to our front
end, we do a little refresh. And
if we scroll up, we still see
nothing. Well, is web three
enabled actually changes. So the
first time that this runs, is
web three enabled probably is
false. But when it turns to
true, we want to we want to run
this section in our little
dependency array. We're going to
add this in here, right? And the
reason that it's false to start
with is because of exactly what
we showed in that manual header,
right? What does it do? Well,
first, we check to see after we
do a refresh, if window dot
local storage get item is
connected, then we call Enable
Web three, which will make this
enabled. So in our lottery
entrance, is what they're
enabled starts off as false when
we do a refresh. And then the
browser checks the local storage
says, oh, web three should be
enabled, let's enable it and
turn to true. So now if we hit
save, and we do a little refresh
in our console, we can now see
the logged out entrance fee. So
then we'll switch this to
entrance fee from contract. Now,
we also probably want to show
this entrance fee on our UI, if
we do let entrance fee, we'll
say equals blank. And we'll take
this and we'll update, you know,
and we'll update this just
saying entrance fee equals await
entrance fee. Cool. Now we have
this as kind of a global
variable, we can add it in here.
And then let's even do a weight
entrance fee. But this whole
thing in parentheses, and then
do.to string, and we can even
console dot log entrance fee.
Now we're adding in a new
browser. But there's still an
issue here. Let's see if you can
spot it, we'll do a little
refresh.
We don't see the entrance fee in
the UI here. But we do see it
good console dot log out, right.
And again, this is going to be
in a way here, what is going on
here will use effect is going to
rerender our browser, right? And
that's what we want is what
three enable goes from false to
true, our browser re renders
watch, once we get our entrance
fee, does our browser rerender?
No, it does not because entrance
fee is just one of these normal
variables, right. So we want to
actually change this from being
just a normal variable to being
a hook because entrance fee does
get updated, but it's not
triggering a rerender. So we
actually want to change this to
being what's called a use state
hook. So you can read some more
on the documentation about the
using the state hook, it's kind
of the same as doing let
entrance fee, you know, equals
blah, blah, blah, and setting it
below. But it also will trigger
a rerender for us. And to do it,
we actually do const entrance
fee, comma, set entrance fee
equals use state zero import use
state from react as well. So
basically, entrance fee is going
to be our value, right, so if we
do console dot log entrance fee,
it's going to print out the
entrance fee entrance fee is
going to be the variable we call
to get the entrance fee, the
entrance fee is going to be the
function we call to update or
set that entrance fee. And
whatever that this entrance fee
variable is set, we trigger a
rerender. From the front end, we
have the state or the actual
variable in the function to
update it. And then in the use
state here, we just give it its
starting values we're saying
entrance fee is going to start
out as zero. So now that we know
that, let's go back down here,
and instead of saying entrance
fee equals this, we can say
const entrance fee from call
equals away entrance fee.to
string and then we can say set
entrance fee to this entrance
fee from call. And now when we
set the use state, we're going
to trigger a rerender. So
entrance fee will actually be
populated. Now if we go to our
browser, do a little refresh
here. We can see that the
entrance fee has indeed been re
rendered here and we can
actually see it here. We see the
console dot log of zero here
even though we're doing console
dot log entrance fee because
this set entrance to function
hasn't finished running it
basically. So we're just gonna
get rid of that line will
refresh and Bada bing bada boom,
this huge number is kind of
gross. We might even want to
update it so that it looks a
little bit nicer. So once again,
we can import ethers, ethers
from ethers. And down below,
we'll do a little ethers dot
utils dot format units. And
we'll do entrance fee from call
and we'll do a comma and type
in. And if we refresh on the
front end, now we can see,
entrance fee is 0.1. So we can
even label this we'll say
entrance fee, blah, blah, blah.
Now if we do a little refresh on
the front end, entrance fee 0.1
E.
Finally, we have the entrance
fee, and now uses finally on our
function to enter the lottery.
So let's finally uncomment this
out. And for message value,
we're going to want to use this
entrance fee. And I'm realizing
it's actually better to store
this in its raw to string
format. So we're going to undo
this part that we just did.
We're going to add it down here.
So we're going to ethers, that
format units, entrance fee,
comma, ether, like that. So that
like that, and let's comment
this back out real quick. So
that at least in the UI, it
shows up at 0.1. But on the back
end, we're actually going to
save it as its raw, and have way
value. So we're saying that we
have this entrance fee and what
we can do uncomment, this, we
can just grab this entrance fee,
and plop it in here. So we need
to make a button that's gonna do
that. Now again, we want to make
our code that all this works,
even if we're connected to a
supported chain, though. So
before we even add this, right,
if we switch from hard hat to
like, Aetherium main net, do a
little refresh. We're getting
kind of get an error here,
because we're calling get
entrance fee.to string on an
address that doesn't exist,
right? So it's gonna get really
confused and be like, hey, what,
what are you doing here? Let's
add a little button here so that
we can actually enter the
raffle. Before we actually do
that, let's make sure that we
can only call the function so
long as there actually is a
raffle address. So we'll do
raffle address. And we'll do
this ternary operator once
again. So that only if this
raffle address is valid, right?
And it's not, no, we'll add all
this code here, right. So we'll
say if the raffle address
exists, we're going to do some
stuff. And for now, we can
actually just copy paste this
line, stick it in here. And then
otherwise, we'll say div.
Excellence div, close it off.
We'll save reformat, great.
We'll say no raffle address,
detected. Now we'll just do all
of our code in this section up
here. So we have this little div
here, which is great. Inside of
this div, let's add a button.
Button button, we'll save it got
a little button here, we'll have
it say, enter raffle. And we'll
say on click, well, we're going
to do some JavaScript. So let's
do some JavaScript, we want to
call an async function async
function. So I know the double
brackets is going to be
confusing, right. But these
brackets allow us to do
JavaScript in our HTML, or JSX,
or whatever. And these brackets
represent this function, it's
going to an async function. And
we're gonna say, await, enter
raffle. And that's it. So let's
go back to the front end. Now we
have a little enter raffle
function. If we do refresh,
let's just make sure our account
is reset here. So we're gonna go
down to settings, advanced,
reset accounts, yes. I hit ENTER
raffle. metamath does indeed pop
up. And we can go ahead and
confirm. Awesome, okay, we can
now enter our raffle. We're
doing incredibly well with this.
As you saw, we just got that pop
up. And that was pretty much it,
right? It's not very helpful for
the users who are following
along with this to look at this
and go, Okay, did it go through?
Or we did it fail, like, what,
what just happened? So what we
want to do is create what's
called notifications, right? We
want a little pop up saying,
Hey, you sent your transaction,
great job, we're going to use a
library. Again, we're going to
use the web through UI Kit,
which comes with some
notifications that we can go
ahead and use. So if you come to
this little interactive thing,
which is right in their GitHub,
there's a whole bunch of stuff
in here. And you can actually
click around and play with
different buttons and different
things. And you can actually go
ahead and even go to docs for
each one of these. And you can
go show code. And you can
literally like copy paste code
into your project, like whatever
you want to do styling and
everything for us. So back in
our app dot j s, we're going to
add import, no to vacations
provider from web three UI kit
and inside of the Morales
provider, but outside of the
components, we're gonna do
notification provider
notification provide Add it like
this. So it goes Morales
provider notification provider
component. So wrapping our
component in this notifications
thing, and that's notification
provider not notifications. And
this is going to allow us to
actually make notifications back
in our lottery entrance. Back in
our lottery entrance, we're
gonna scroll up to the top,
we're going to import a hook
those notifications called us
know, to the occasion from web
three UI kit. And this use
notification gives us this thing
back called a dispatch. So I'm
gonna say const, dispatch,
equals use notification. So use
notification returns this
dispatch, and this dispatch is
like a little pop up that will
give us so down here, when we
call this enter raffle, we're
gonna give it a little some
parameters in here, we're gonna
say on success, these functions
come with onsuccess, they come
with onComplete, they come with
an error, all this stuff. And
when this function is
successful, we'll do handle
success, we'll create a new
handle success function that
will handle the success. And
this is Patrick from the future
coming back to show one
additional point. I know I
mentioned it, but it is really
good to add this on error, colon
error console dot log error for
any run contract functions, even
the reads, If any of your run
contract functions break, you
won't know. So definitely want
to add this on error error
console dot log error to all of
your run contract functions. So
up here, before the return,
we'll create a new const handle
success. We'll say this is an
async function async function
that takes the transaction as
input parameters. And remember,
you can turn functions into
constant variables. And we'll
say await TX dot Wait, one, so
we'll wait for that transaction
to go through. And then we'll
create another function called
handle new notification, dx. And
you'll see why I'm doing it like
this in a minute. And we'll say
const and Linoone notification,
this is just going to be a
synchronous function because we
don't need it to be async. And
we're just going to call this
dispatch, we're going to set up
this notification basically. So
we'll say notify, or dispatch,
and then we'll add the
parameters in here. So it takes
an object as a parameter, we'll
say type info. Message, it's
going to be transaction
complete, the title is going to
be TX notification. Jose, Shawn,
we're going to say, top are and
then icon, we're going to say a
little bell.
And you can find all this stuff
right in here, type icon
position, you can read all about
the different parameters you can
kind of set this up with so
handle new notification handle
success. So we're saying, enter
raffle once this transaction is
successful, call this handle
success function, which is going
to call handle new notification.
Okay. And you'll see why we
split this into two instead of
just having handle success. Also
do the dispatch. When we press
our enter raffle button, we're
going to call enter raffle is
successful, we're going to call
handle success. We're going to
wait for that transaction to
finish Yes, it passes a
parameter to our handle success
function. And then all we're
going to do is we're going to
call handle new notification.
And we're going to dispatch
we're going to launch one of
these notifications. So back
here, let's hit enter raffle.
metamath pops up will confirm.
And after it completes, we get
this wonderful transaction
notification transaction
complete, right. So we've let
the user know, great job, you've
submitted a transaction. Great
work. So this is great. We're
giving our users some helpful
pieces here. Now let's add a
little bit more here so that the
users know what else is going on
with this lottery. But we need
to display a little bit more
data, right, let's display how
many people are in this lottery.
How many people are in this
game. And we can do that. Of
course, because we have a number
players command. We also
probably want to get the recent
winner. And we can do that as
well. Up here, we're going to
copy this get entrance fee,
we're going to create another
one called Get num players. And
this is going to call go back to
raffle dot soul. It's going to
call get number of players
actually so let's just call it
call it the same thing. Get
number of players and we're
going to call and get number of
players. And to store this
value. Once again up at the top.
We're going to copy this line,
paste it right and we'll do non
players. And then we'll do set
num players. And then we'll copy
this line again. A recent winner
so we'll do recent Winner.
Winner will do Set, recent
winner, then we'll copy this
again, instead of getting number
players will do get get recent
winner. So we'll call it get
recent winner get recent winner
in our use effect, let's do more
than just get the entrance fee,
let's get everything. So we can
say const num players, from call
equals, we'll do a weight, get
number of players.to string, and
then we'll do set set num
players do like that. So we'll
do set num players, num players
from call. And then we'll also
do const recent winner from call
this is going to be await get
recent winner. And we might need
to wrap this to string but I
think I don't think we need to.
So we'll do set recent winner
paste that in here. So now we've
had a number of players, we've
added a recent winner. Let's
come back down here. We have an
entrance fee. Let's go ahead and
do number of players. And we'll
add number of players or what
did we call it? Oh my god, we
called setting employers twice
oops, it's called non players,
scroll down players gonna be non
players, and then we'll do
recent winner.
And then we'll add in the recent
winner. Awesome. Okay, entrance
fees 0.1 eath number of players
to recent winner is nobody here.
And if we go ahead and we enter
the raffle metamath pops up.
We'll go ahead and confirm. Once
a transaction goes through,
we'll get transaction complete.
And if we do a refresh, we see
the number of players has
updated. But we had to refresh
which is kind of annoying,
right, let's enter the raffle
again, we'll go confirm
transaction complete. But this
didn't rerender. Right. So we
want to set something up so that
we automatically rerender. And
guess what's going to do that
the handle success that we were
talking about before. That's
right, all of this update UI
stuff, we can actually pull out
of the use effect. So we're
going to copy it all deleted
there. And we're going to have
it be its own standalone
function like this. And then in
our handle success, whenever
this successful transaction goes
through, we're going to update
the UI, right? So handle success
handled new notification, and
we're going to update the white.
So now if we go back here, let's
enter the lottery. Let's
confirm, we see we get the five
and we get transaction
Notification. Now we want to
test getting a recent winner
here. So what we can do,
actually back in our hard hat
project is we want to create a
new script. And I actually
already created it for you,
that's going to mock the
channeling VRF. And that's going
to mock being a keepers. So all
this is really doing is pretty
much exactly what our tests were
doing. If you want to pause
right now and look through this
yourself, pause here and add
this mock off chain, which is
both keepers and VRF. Or you can
just go to the GitHub repo here.
Just go to the GitHub repo for
Lesson Nine. It's already in
scripts go down to scripts
Markov chain, you can just copy
paste it here. Because I want to
test that that recent winner. So
in my hard hat, smart contract
lottery, so we'll do yarn,
hardhats run scripts, slash mock
off chain dash test network
local host, we're going to mock
you know, basically picking a
winner from an upkeep with
Request ID one, we're on a local
network. Okay, let's pretend the
recent winner was so and so. And
what we can do is we can do a
little refresh here, we can see
we have a winner updated. Boom.
Now we're gonna clean up the UI.
But I want to talk about a
couple of things. Before we do
that, because we're almost done
with this section. Something I
want to make really clear
because it confused me a little
bit is that this onsuccess isn't
checking that the transaction
has a block confirmation, it's
just checking to see that the
transaction was successfully
sent to Metamask. So onsuccess
checks to see a transaction is
successfully sent the Metamask.
And that's why up in that other
function, we do TX dot wait one
because that's the piece that
actually waits for the
transaction to be confirmed.
Right now we're using Morales to
make once we call that mocking
script, I had to refresh the
browser to see the winner here,
right and number of players
obviously got reset to zero,
which is great. That's not
ideal. Ideally, we want our UI
to just automatically update
when some event gets fired. In
our raffle contract, we get this
event emitted. Instead of in our
code doing this await success
here. What we could do is we
could set up a portion to listen
for that event being emitted and
update the front end
accordingly. With that knowledge
we can also listen for the
winner event being emitted. We
could update our front end
instead of having to refresh
it's your cue Yes, and you want
to see if you can add to this
right now, I highly recommend
you do. So
we've pretty much finished all
the functionality. And wow,
you've learned a ton in this
little bit, right? We've learned
about use effects use Morales,
all these hooks, all this stuff,
and we've got a front end that
very nicely handles interacting
with our smart contract. The
only thing is, is it looks
really ugly. This is kind of
gross. So let's make this look
at least a little bit nicer.
There's two things to think
about when it comes to building
these front ends. There's
component libraries, like web
three UI Kit, which we're using,
which gives us kind of like
components that give us, you
know, blocks of code, like this
connect button that are already
formatted for us. And then
there's CSS libraries that
actually will help us format the
rest of our stuff here. So we're
using one of these component
libraries. We're also going to
use one of these formatting
libraries, and the library that
we're going to use is tailwind.
And the reason that we're going
to use tailwind CSS is because
it's really popular. If you want
to learn CSS, there's some
wonderful resources that you can
use to learn CSS web three
schools is one that I've used a
ton. So there's going to be a
link to that in the GitHub repo
associated with this course so
that you can make your websites
look pretty when formatting
stuff but we are actually going
to work with tailwind because
it's going to make us doing CSS
stuff a lot easier. Since we're
using tailwind with next Jas.
There's actually a wonderful
little guide here for installing
tailwind with next Jas. And
we're gonna go basically go
ahead and follow along with
this. This link is available in
the GitHub repo associated with
this course with this lesson. So
we've already created our
project we've seeded into our
project. Now we're gonna go
ahead and install tailwind npm
install dash D instead, since
we're using yarn, we're going to
do yarn or pop this open, green
new yarn, add dash dash Dev,
paste those three in tailwind
CSS, post CSS and then
autoprefixer and it's the three
of these that are going to
basically make up tailwind with
next Jas. Once we have those
we're going to basically init
tailwind and make a config file
for tailwind. So we're gonna do
yarn tailwind CSS and it does p
yarn tailwind CSS init dash P
will run that. This is going to
give us this post CSS dot config
dot j s and this tailwind dot
config dot j s and what we're
going to want to do is literally
just hit this copy button, and
we're going to update our
tailwind.config.js tailwind Jas
so that it says okay, all of
this stuff, anything in Pages
anything with.js.ts dot JSX or
TSX. And anything in these
components, anything in those
two folders is going to be
considered tailwind double. We
want to use tailwind on these
two folders. Then we're going to
add the tailwind directives to
our global CSS files. So if we
go back, we're going to styles
Global's we're going to
overwrite everything in here
with ADD tailwind base and add
tailwind components at tailwind
utilities. And this makes it so
that our global CSS file uses
tailwind. Now, you'll see like
unknown rule at tailwind, what
we can do is we can go to
components, what we can do is we
can look up this post CSS
language support extension,
paste that in here, boom, let's
go ahead and install this. And
now we get those little
underscores to go away, which is
really nice. Now, per usual, we
can just do NPM, run Dev and
start adding tailwind to our
divs. Now what tailwind does is
allows us in our divs to set
everything as a class name, and
then just set some real
minimalistic text in these class
names here. So let's look at our
smart contract lottery here.
We've just tailwind did it. So
it already has been updated a
little bit. Let's update our
header here. Well, let's see. We
want to give our header a border
from the tailwind. We'll do a
quick search. Look a border we
can see all this border stuff
like border width border this
border that say we want a border
on the bottom, we can see we can
get a border on the bottom with
something like this. Let's do
border on the bottom with a
width of two pixels. We just do
border b two. So I'm going to
copy border B to do border b
two, I'm going to save it and
what we need to do for our CSS
and everything to take effect.
Go ahead and kill the front end.
And then we'll rerun it with
yarn Dev. Go back to our front
end now. Give it a little
refresh and Okay, cool. Now we
have a little border here. So
we're starting to add some stuff
and it's just not a whole lot
yet. Oh, and then we can also
add tailwind to me go to
Extensions. We can also look up
tailwind. There's a tailwind
extension here. So I'm just
going to add a whole bunch of
stuff in here. We're gonna do
flex, flex row.
We're gonna make our
decentralized lottery and h one
which stands for like header
one. Do class name equals, we'll
do the y dash force. We'll give
it padding the top of form the X
padding on the x axis of four.
We'll make it bold font and
we'll make the text three XL
size. So we'll make everything
bigger. Cool. Then we'll do one
more, we'll wrap our Connect
button in a div. So we'll say
div class name equals, and we'll
give it a an automatic left
margin. We'll do py too. So some
y padding, some x padding. See
what we have done. Okay. Now if
we zoom out a little bit, we can
see, if we close this too, we
can see now our Connect button
is on the side here. And they're
kind of separated like that. And
I think that looks nice. So
we're going to keep that now
we're going to go back to our
lottery entrance, we're going to
change this up just a hair,
we'll say div class name equals
P. Five, we'll make our button
look really nice. We'll say
class name equals background
blue 500. When we hover over, it
will say, background blue 700.
So now if I just say that, and
when we hover over it, it looks
a little different, that's
really nice. We'll say text is
white, we'll say the font is
bold, we'll give it some white
padding, I'll give it some x
padding, we'll have the bunbee
rounded, and we'll give it a
margin left auto, now looks a
lot better, right? That's a lot
prettier. We're just going to be
doing some basic CSS here just
to make it look a little bit
nicer, right, but just that by
itself already made this lottery
button look a lot cooler. Now
some functionality that we
didn't add here. So we need to
add a disabled, kind of like
what we did before. And in our
enter a raffle it comes with,
like I said, is loading and it
is fetching. None of our
transaction is loading or
fetching, we'll just make this
disabled. So we'll say is
loading or is fetching this will
be disabled. Right? Now, if we
go back to the front, we hit
enter raffle, go ahead and hit
confirm, we can add a CSS for
it. But when a transaction is
loading, they will not be able
to click that button anymore,
which that's something else
pretty that we want to do
speaking of is loading and is
fetching. When it's loading or
fetching, we probably want it to
have that like little spinny
thing right when we hit it right
now. And mash is pops up. And we
can confirm but it would be cool
if it had like a little spinny
thing here, right. So you can
usually just Google like how to
add spinny thing or stuff like
that, and you'll get something.
But you can again, you can just
copy paste this from my code,
I'm going to show you what I
ended up doing for this section.
And we're gonna say is, if is
loading or is fetching. And
we're going to use that ternary
operator all the time, then in
here, we're going to do a little
div. And otherwise, we're going
to do a different div for
loading or for fetching, we're
going to add like a little
spinny thing in here. So we're
going to add class name equals.
If we're loading, we're going to
add this little spinny thing,
which I'll show you what it
looks like in a second. And if
we're not loading, we're just
gonna do enter, raffle like
that. So we'll come back to the
front end, see answer raffle,
we'll click the button. Now we
get this cute little spinny
thing, confirm transaction goes
through. So anything goes away.
Nice. Well, let's put these on
different lines. So we'll just
do
so those will be on different
lines. Now boom, entrance fee,
number players recent winner,
once a lottery now will confirm
transaction complete number of
players has gone up and we have
done it. Now this looks a lot
nicer. It's clearly not perfect,
but it's much easier to read
than kind of that lump that we
had before. And the reason I
wanted to show you this was
really just kind of giving you
your footholds for making these
look a little bit nicer. This
definitely isn't a CSS course.
Oh, wow. Okay, this is
phenomenal. We have an app that
we really like. And we're like,
you know what, we want to deploy
this bad, Larry, let's talk
about how we can deploy this,
this section is going to be
optional, okay, because I'm
going to deploy something to
rank B and deploying to test
sets can take a long time. So
we're going to deploy our
contracts to rink B. And then
website to a hosting provider.
So first, let's talk about
hosting providers for a quick
second, if we want to host our
beautiful website that we just
created, there are ways to
deploy it using things like for
cell or Google Cloud, or AWS.
Nettle. Phi is another really
popular one there, all these
different places that we can
deploy our application. Now, the
thing about these though, is
that these are all centralized
deployment places, having a
centralized deployment
application can still be
incredibly important, right? If
we look at ether scan for a
second ether scan is a
centralized application right at
the end of the day, but it's
still one that we've been using
a lot. However, if we want to
have a front end that's
decentralized. Well, that's a
little bit harder. The more
important thing for us is that
our back end, our smart
contracts are decentralized,
right? That's the most important
thing because that will give
users the ability to interact
with our logic in a
decentralized way. But maybe we
also want our front ends
decentralized. Now at some point
we will still use a centralized
service Like VSL to deploy an
application, and I'll show you
why when we get there, there's
some features that right now,
they're really just hard to do
without like a really solid
centralized back end. What's
important to keep in mind is
that our back end, the logic of
our contract is on a
decentralized blockchain. So
even if we host the front end on
a centralized hosting provider,
using some type of centralized
database to make the front end
easier to work with, the logic
of the application is
decentralized. And that's the
most important piece. So I'm
going to give you some tools
later on, and how to introduce
more of these feature richness.
If you choose to do so doing so
will add a centralized component
on your front end. And it's
something to keep in mind,
depending on how you want your
architecture. So when doing that
just be absolutely sure that the
smart contracts on the back end
are deployed are decentralized
on one of these blockchains.
Now, we'll learn about some of
those centralized ways to do
that in a later section. For
now, let's learn how to deploy
this front end in a more
decentralized way.
And the tool that we're going to
use is a tool called IPFS. Now,
let me explain a little bit
about how IPFS works. It's this
distributed decentralized data
structure. That's not exactly a
blockchain. But it's similar to
a blockchain. There's no mining,
though. But there is pinning
data, you can add data to this.
So let me explain how this
actually works. And you can read
how this works on the site,
there's going to be a link to
this and the GitHub repo
associated with this course. But
we give you my basic take on it.
So we have our code, or our
file, or whatever it is, right,
we have some piece of data. Now
as we know, when you really have
anything, you can hash that
thing, you can hash that data,
right, so you can get a unique
output. So and that's actually
the first thing that IPFS does.
It hashes our data to get a
unique hash, that only points to
that data. Yes, a massive code
file a ton of text. Yes, you can
encode all of that into a single
hash function, your IPFS node
does this hashing for you. And
every single IPFS node on the
planet has the exact same
hashing function, kind of like a
blockchain, right, they all kind
of run this same spec, the same
specification. So we can hash
our data on our IPFS node and
get this unique output. What we
can do then is we can pin that
data or pin that code, or pin
that file or pin that whatever,
to our node, we have some data,
we get a unique hash of it, all
it does is host this data and
have these hashes. That's it,
our node is connected to a
network of other IPFS nodes. So
there's a massive network of
people running IPFS nodes,
they're incredibly lightweight,
way lighter weight than any
other blockchain node. And they
all talk to each other. So if I
asked the network, hey, I want
to get this hash. All these
nodes would talk to each other.
And eventually they'd reach up
at our node saying, Oh, I found
a node that has that hash.
Here's the file associated with
it. Now, you might be thinking,
Okay, well, that's kind of
centralized, because we have the
data on one node here, right?
Well, you're right, well, here's
the thing, what other nodes can
do is they can say, oh, that
data looks really cool, I want
to have that persist, what they
can do is they can pin your
hash, they can pin your data,
and they'll get a copy of your
data on their node. And you can
keep doing this. And so you
easily allow an entire network
to easily replicate any code or
any data in a decentralized
sense. And they're incredibly
easy to spin up. And they're
incredibly easy to work with
something about IPFS, that makes
it drastically different than a
blockchain is the can't do smart
contract, there's no execution,
it can really only store it's
just decentralized storage that
IPFS can do. Now, the issue here
is that in order for our data to
really be decentralized, another
node does need to pin our data,
right? Because if we're the only
IPFS node that's got this hash,
it's kind of centralized on our
node, if our node goes down,
that data is gone, and the
network won't be able to access
that data anymore. So we'll talk
about strategies in the future
about having other people pin
your data. But for now, this is
a way we can host data, we can
send code and have it be in a
decentralized context. So unlike
a blockchain, where every single
node in a blockchain is going to
have a copy of the entire
blockchain IPFS nodes get to
optionally choose which data
they want to pin, and they can't
do any execution. So you could
have an IPFS node, half a
megabyte, and you could have an
IPFS node, that several
terabytes, it's up to the node
operators, how much data and
what data they want to pin. Now
that we know about IPFS.
Let's actually deploy our
wonderful application to IPFS so
that anybody can use it and
anybody can connect to it. So
long as our node is up. Are you
ready? Okay, get excited here.
We're first going to do this
kind of the Manuel Wait, because
I'm going to show you how to
install IPFS. And work with
IPFS. Hit get started, there's a
number of ways to install and
work with IPFS, you can get it
with a desktop application, get
a command line. And then we can
also add IPFS to our browser
using something like brave or I
think Firefox to some this IPFS
router is automatically built
it. But if using something like
Chrome, you might have to add a
little companion, because what
we want to do is we can actually
use those little hashes as URLs
for websites, right, and so we
want to be able to put that URL
in our browser and connect to
that node or that piece of code.
So what we're gonna do is we're
gonna have you install the IPFS
desktop, so you're gonna hit
that. And when you do that, you
should be able to open up IPFS.
Now, if you install it, you
might get this little guy, this
little box here in your upper
section. Otherwise, you might be
able to open it up with with
IPFS desktop and see it as a
regular desktop app. Well, once
you install it, you might see
IPFS is running, you can restart
stop, you can do all this stuff,
we're gonna go to the file
section, and we're gonna get a
little pop up that looks like
this. Now, I've got a ton of
stuff in here, because I've been
using IPFS for some time in
here, right now, you might have
no data. So let's just go ahead
and import some file. And maybe
for now we'll just import, you
know, our next dot config dot j
s, right? It doesn't matter,
just import something. And now
in here, we have this next dot
config dot j s or whatever file
you import it. So what we can do
with this is we can actually
copy the CID. And we can view
this in our browser. So if we do
IPFS dot dot slash slash, and we
paste it in, we hit enter, we
can give our browser access to
actually rendering IPFS URLs. If
using brave, you can just do use
a brave local IPFS node or let's
go ahead and download this IPFS
companion. So we'll get IPFS
companion, there's a Firefox
install for Chrome brave, blah,
blah, blah. So I'm gonna go to
the Chrome store to get it for
brave, we're just going to hit
Add to brave add extension. But
once you download it, you'll get
something that looks like this.
Even on a little browser
companion, we can see like
import, we can see stuff about
our node, if we click our node,
we will see a very similar
setup. But now that we have the
companion in our browser, we can
copy that Cid that hash. Now
brave, we can just do use brave
local IPFS node, and will
automatically get dropped into
the file. Now, if IPFS companion
doesn't work for you, and you
can't see the URL inside of
something like Google Chrome or
some other browser, what you can
do is you can use something
called the IPFS gateway. Now
using a gateway, you're not
actually directly requesting the
data through IPFS requesting the
data through another server,
which is requesting it through
IPFS. But if you are having some
trouble accessing these files,
you can use the gateway. So what
you'll do is we'll do HTTPS,
slash IPFS, slash and then paste
the hash code there. And you'll
be able to see your file. Now if
you do it like this, you won't
even need IPFS companion at all.
So we're going to deploy our
website to IPFS. So that anybody
else who wants to pin this can,
and we will now have the ability
to have an incorruptible, in
unputdownable website, which is
just awesome. We're going to
learn how to do this the wrong
way first, and then we're going
to use a tool that's going to
make it a lot easier for us.
Okay, so first, let's go to our
website here. And, and if you
want to deploy to rink B, go
ahead and feel free. Just
remember to make sure that your
contract addresses file updates
accordingly. Okay. Now, next,
Jas has the ability to create
static websites. And that's
going to be an important term to
know we're going to make a
static website. At the moment,
we don't want our website to be
tangled with any server stuff.
And the reason we we don't want
it to be tangled with any server
stuff is because if our website
runs with server stuff, and we
deploy it to IPFS, will IPFS
doesn't have the ability to run
any code, it just hosts code. If
our front end has any server
stuff, it won't work. Now, in
its current state IPFS can't
come to our project and know
what to do, right, it doesn't
know how to do yarn dev can't do
yarn Dev. So we need to put all
of our code into its static
equivalents. So to do that,
we're gonna do yarn build. And
if again, if we look at our
package dot JSON, it comes with
this build, which just runs next
build. And running this build
command is going to build our
code, what's called like a
production build, creating an
optimized production build here.
And we'll get something that
looks like this. And we can see
this point down here. Static,
automatically rendered as static
HTML uses no initial props.
There's some server based
applications that next Jas comes
with that if we use them. Our
static build won't work. And
actually, you'll see when we run
yarn, next export, it'll fail if
you have any that non static
stuff. So let's Go ahead and try
yarn next export. And let's see
if it fails, it didn't fail, we
now have a new folder called
out. And this is our folder,
that's just pure static code and
that we can use on IPFS. In a
later section, I'll show you
what it looks like when you
don't use some of those static
things. Both Morales and next
Jas have the optionality to not
have static code. So we'll just
want to keep that in mind. So
now that we have this out
folder, we can go back to IPFS.
And we can import a folder,
we're going to import that whole
folder in here. So hit that hit
that import button and go to the
folder. Where that is mine is in
next year smart contract lottery
out. So now we're going to
upload this to our IPFS node.
Once it's done, we'll get this
little checkmark. And we can go
through IPFS files and see our
output here. What we can do,
let's go ahead and pin this to
our node, we'll pin it to our
local node here. And now once
it's up, we can copy the CID and
go back to brave or chrome or
whatever. You type in IPFS colon
slash slash, paste that in
there. And we immediately get
dropped into our smart contract
lottery in a browser. And we see
hi from lottery, no raffle
address detected, because right
now the way I set mine up Was it
only works with, you know, our
local hard hats, let's connect
our Metamask we'll hit the
connect button, connect, and
voila, we are right back where
we were. But with our data
stored in IPFS, we can enter
raffle as long as our node is
running a confirm. And we see
exactly what we get in our local
browsers. So this is phenomenal.
Now that I've shown you how to
do this, this is the manual way
of adding our code to IPFS. Let
me show you the easier way of
adding your code to IPFS we're
gonna go to this site called
fleek HQ. Go to fleek.co. And to
get to it, I'm going to turn my
my IPFS companion note off
because of some of the oddities
with working with brave but now
we're here@flickr.co fleek.co
makes it easy to to deploy
websites and apps to the new
open web permissionless,
trustless, censorship resistant,
etc. I like to think about it as
kind of like an auto deployment
for our websites. And
additionally, it does some
things to help out with that
problem. I was talking about how
we want to get other nodes to
pin our data. So it helps us out
with that. So let me show you
what it does. So let's go ahead,
we'll sign up. And why don't you
know, you can sign in with
GitHub. So if you have your
GitHub, definitely want to sign
in with GitHub here. Because
we're going to use GitHub to
actually help us automatically
deploy. So we'll authorize fleet
to work with our GitHub. You've
authorized your GitHub, let's go
ahead and add a new site or add
new site. Now we can use fleet
to just automatically deploy
websites, once we push them to
our GitHub. So we can come to
our GitHub once again. And click
the little plus button, we'll do
a new repository. We'll call
this next Jas smart contract,
lottery Free Code Camp. We'll
make it public create the
repository. Let's push all this
code to GitHub. We did it once
before, let's do it again. We'll
do git add, we'll do a little
dot, then we'll do git commit
minus m, say like initial commit
or whatever. We'll do git
remote, add origin, and then
we'll grab that URL, paste it
right here. And then we'll just
do git push origin, main. Now we
go back to our application we
see it in here we can do is back
in our fleek. We can connect
with GitHub, we're going to say
only select repositories, we're
only going to do this next js
application, this next JS get
we're going to install an
Authorize. Authorize Great. So
now we're going to pick a repo
we've picked a repo, we're going
to choose this application. And
we're going to use IPFS as our
hosting service. And now we're
going to add our information in
here. So we're going to use the
main branch. Here's the repo.
There's gonna be our framework
is gonna be next Jas. So we're
do fleek next. Jas, we're using
yarn. So we're gonna do yarn
install, and yarn, run build,
and then yarn run export. If you
want you could also just do
yarn, yarn build and yarn run
export, those are gonna be the
same thing. Publish directory is
going to be out and then we just
hit Deploy site, yarn, next
export as the last command, not
yarn, run, export. The accident
did the wrong one, you go over
deploys. Click on this, go to
deploy settings and then Edit
Settings and then just change it
to yarn. Next, export save. Then
we'll go back to deploys and
trigger deploy, if you did the
wrong one that was just a
learning opportunity for you to
learn where the settings are
after you deploy. And what this
is going to do is we're going to
do to deploy, it's going to run
those three commands yarn build,
yarn export, it's going to run
everything. And then it's going
to deploy a site for us both on
IPFS. And it's going to give a
regular URL that we can use for
normies, if you will. And while
this deploys, you'll actually
see down here we have this thing
called file coin di D in deal
proposal, Cid IPFS. Like I said,
we need other people to host our
node. File coin is actually a
blockchain that helps you pin
your data and uses decentralized
storage to do so. And fleek
helps you create those deals and
helps you pin your data with
this filecoin Blockchain
filecoin is one definitely to
take a look at. And then after a
while, you might have to wait a
little bit. And once it's done,
get a little deployed website,
we go back to hosting, we click
on our thing we can see we have
like a little website here. And
if we click it, we get a normal
URL for connecting and
interacting with our website,
you might even see this little
IPFS thing which will connect to
your IPFS node. And
additionally, we scroll down in
here we can see current IPFS
hash, so we can just stick that
in, um, and Bada bing, we have
an IP Fs deployed application.
Now what's cool is let's say I
make some changes, you know,
I'll go to lottery entrance. And
I'll do, I'll scroll on the
bottom to recent winner, I'll
make a new div. What a close the
div off, we'll save git add dot
Git commit minus m, add a dot
git push origin mean.
In our GitHub, we'll do a little
refresh, add a.as, the most
recently added one, go back over
to fleek. Go back to hosting
click on the section that we
just made go to deploys, and
you'll see there's a new deploy
going through. So it
automatically deploys your new
site, it'll automatically create
a new IPFS hash for your new
data. However, it'll still be on
this holy bird, you know, or
whatever your URL is here. And
this is kind of just a router
for IPSs. So that people without
IPFS connected can also connect
to this still. And now that my
application is done, pushing
automatically, with fleek, we
can see what's up being post in
my application here. Now, like I
said, filecoin isn't going to be
a technology, we're gonna go too
deep into introduce ourselves.
But like I was just saying IPFS
does have this limitation. It
doesn't have data persistence,
you have to have people pin your
data, in order for it to stay
distributed, and stay
decentralized. File coin is a
blockchain dedicated to keeping
this data, both decentralized
and persistent. And to give us a
better understanding of
filecoin. We actually have Ali
here to give us an overview.
Take it away, Ali. Hello, I'm
Ali, and I'm a developer
advocate here at the filecoin
Foundation, which works closely
with protocol labs and IPFS.
Just a quick note, protocol Labs
is our r&d arm. So it works on
creating tooling and technology
for a truly open and democratic
internet and web. And it's
building out some of the
foundational tooling like IPFS,
and filecoin, which are two
separate projects to enable
that. And hopefully, today,
because you're here to build, I
want to impart on you the
knowledge and tools you need to
get started with both of those
projects. So as anyone that's
kind of played around in this
ecosystem, or tech, in general
would know, data is an
absolutely essential part of our
daily lives. And not
surprisingly, it's also a super
fast growing field in web three,
and one, that's fundamental one,
and it's one of the fundamental
necessities of the decentralized
web stack as well. So the
current model of centralization
that's grown up, and basically
out of a lack of an identity
layer on the internet, is one
where only a few big companies
offer storage, and only a few
entities hold our data for
authorization purposes. And this
is an obvious problem, both in
terms of being an attack vector
for data mining, so without
data, getting leaked through
insecure service to third
parties, and also creating a
data resilience problem. So
whole services go down every
time one of these companies
servers does and we've
definitely seen that. So it
really leads to the question,
why aren't we designing the web
for the autonomy and resilience
we need in the first place? And
how do we store data in a way
that aligns with both the
original vision of the internet
as an open place for knowledge
sharing and collaboration, and,
and, and in a way that agrees
with the web three mission as
well. So these are the core
problems we're solving with IPFS
and file coin. Firstly, IPFS is
a distributed system for storing
and accessing files, folders,
websites, applications and data.
And it's designed to be able to
work even when the networks
between planets, so it's a
distributed by design, it has no
central authority servers, and
it's designed to be offline
first for resilience. And it's
not just a fancy name for
another peer to peer network
either. Because the nice thing
about the IPFS protocol is the
standard it uses for addressing
content on the network. IPFS is
unique because rather than using
traditional methods we might be
with familiar with from the web,
like those are location parts
that point to a particular HTTP
address where your content may
or may not be available and
stored. IPFS uses content
addressing so content addressing
means that each piece of data,
each meme or even full file
system has its own unique
cryptographically verifiable
fingerprint, you might call it.
So if you change even one pixel
of your main image, for example,
then the content ID or Cid
associated with it also changes.
So importantly, this hash
function is also upgradeable. So
let's say quantum computing
breaks out current secure hash
algorithms, we can upgrade the
standard we use. And it means
you will always get the same
content returned by an IPFS. Cid
as what you expect. So this is
fundamentally important, because
when you don't have to care
where the data comes from, you
open up the web to massively
distributed storage systems.
Hello, decentralization. So now
we have a really important and
valuable protocol that enables
distribution at scale. And it
provides verifiability of data
to serve and retrieve content on
the web. And not just for web
three, either, but also for all
web, or tech use cases. The
problem is, and it's one that
the early internet also faced,
who's going to ensure the
persistence and permanence of
all this data on the network. So
unless you're running your own
nodes 24/7, or your content is
really popular or other nodes
decide to altruistically store
your data. Because I think it's
important, then this data can
become unreliable because
they're no longer actively
hosted on any nodes on the
network's. So to avoid this, you
could also turn to a pinning
service that you pay to keep a
copy of your content around.
Unfortunately, the problem with
this though, is that we're
heading back towards
centralization of data. And
we're creating new data silos
with this solution and losing
the trust lessness and
resilience we're looking for.
And these one a bad solution
prior to file coin, and it's why
they sprung up initially, but we
want a better solution. So this
is where file coin comes in. So
far coins architecture, then
designed to leverage a crypto
economic incentive model
together with cryptographic
proofs in order to ensure data
is stored persistently, highly
reliably and verifiably. It uses
these cryptographic proofs to
also enable smart contract based
permanence. And that means that
it's designed to be as permanent
as you, the data owner want it
to be. It's your data, so it's
your choice. It's also designed
to enable internet scale
capacity. It's currently the
largest distributed storage
network in the world with over
18 million terabytes of capacity
available, which is apparently
about 135 copies of the European
Union's nuclear program, CERN's
data which, which is kind of a
fun fact. It's also file coins
also designed to be and stay
hyper competitive on pricing due
to its market economics. And
this comes down to storage
deals. So to make this network
feasible, filecoin uses storage
deals. And these include two
main consensus mechanisms that
ensure both rewards for good
actors in the system, and
penalties for bad actors. So
when you make a deal with one or
more storage providers to store
your important data, the
provider generates a proof of
replication. So this proves that
the storage provider is storing
a unique copy of your original
data over time to make sure that
this data is persisted. These
storage providers must prove
that they still have random
subsets of this client data and
they create proof of space
times. And these proof this
proof of space time is something
that is stored on the
blockchain. So anyone at any
time can also check that this is
true. And it also makes up the
mechanism by which miners are
rewarded or penalized because
you have to stake Phil on the
network in order to become a
storage provider. So when a
storage deal comes to an end, or
user can you can opt to let it
expire or renew the deal. If you
opt for renewal, then the
providers again bid to host this
content. So this creates an
efficient market for pricing a
continual efficient market for
pricing as well. It can even go
negative. So the storage
provider can even pay you to
store your data if it's an
important data set due to some
of the block rewards that are
being offered by the filecoin
Foundation as well. So these
mechanisms are what built in not
just data permanence, but data
timeframes, sovereignty, too so
it's your data, it's your
choice. You can decide you want
to store your data for five
minutes or 500 years. It's also
your choice over how much
resilience you want to have that
data so or how many copies of
that data you want to have and
with what store to providers. So
this allows you to comply with
regulations like GDPR. And
there's a growing number of
tools in the ecosystem like
murmurations bit screen that are
allowing for you to do this
filtering. But it also gives you
some guarantees that your data,
you know, if one storage
provided goes down, you know,
surely not 10 of them are going
to go down. So that's a
guarantee for your resilience
there as well.
And this is why IPFS and
filecoin are great complements
of each other. So IPF s gives
you that benefit of content
addressing file coin gives you
persistent guarantees that even
if your computer or your
favorite IPFS pinning service
where to go away, the content
persists. Just as a quick final
note on these concepts as well,
IPFS and file coin is separate
projects, as I mentioned. So
IPFS is a protocol much like
HTTP, whereas file coin is a
blockchain. So IPFS is also
storage layer agnostic, you can
combine it with the storage
layer of your choice. And while
file coin was specifically
designed to complement it, and
we think is a great choice, you
can also store your IPFS data in
the cloud or an other storage
solutions as well. So hopefully,
you've got a good baseline for
why you'd want to use IPFS, and
filecoin. And for those
engineers out there that like a
challenge, and are interested in
working on the base protocols
and code of IPFS, and file coin,
which isn't always easy for the
average user, I'd encourage you
to go and take a look at the
project docs and get hubs and
some of the associated grants
available for extensions to
these open source projects. And
this is a great site here if you
want to get more information
into the nitty gritty and really
dig into the code behind IPFS
and filecoin. And extend some of
that. For those of you that just
want to build out of the box
though. And this is definitely a
camp that I often fall into. I
want to talk about some of the
dev tooling and storage helpers
that make it easy for you to get
started. So firstly, Flake Flake
is one of my favorite IPFS dev
tools. And projects Flake is a
CI CD tool that you can use to
deploy your apps for free as
simply as easy as you would with
some of the web tools you might
web to tools you might be
familiar with like Netlify
oversell. The big difference,
though, is fleek uses IPFS to
host your site or app. And it
even offers an AES domain
routing on their platform. So if
you're deploying a front end
app, I would encourage you to
use fleek to make it more
distributed instead of some of
the traditional web two tools.
It's just as easy, I promise. So
another one of my favorite tools
is NFT storage, storing your NFT
metadata immutably and
persistently, as you already
probably know, is integral to
keeping the main value
proposition of NF Ts, then on
fungibility. So if you're not
storing this data on chain,
which obviously can become
pretty financially unviable for
large files, then this is
exactly where NF T storage comes
in. So it was specifically
created as a public good to
archive and persist NF T data.
So it's free. And it takes care
of the complexity around firstly
creating an IPFS Cid for this
metadata, and then making
automatic deals with filecoin
storage providers. So it does
this with at least eight storage
providers. So eight times
redundancy and it does it with a
multigenerational timeframe. So
it automatically renews those
deals. Because it's a public
good, it's all free as well. And
it's also super easy to use,
because you just need because
it's a JavaScript service. So
you just need to say import that
as an NPM package or JavaScript
library and then call the API
and NFT dot storage takes care
of the rest. For data that isn't
NF T metadata as well, we built
web three dot storage, web three
storage is designed to give you
those same web two benefits. So
similar to NF T dot storage,
make it super easy for you to
use. And it's got JavaScript and
go client libraries.
While giving you you know the
power of IPFS and filecoin of
decentralized storage and IPFS
content addressing so it's got
one terabyte after terabyte, one
terabyte of free storage with
that. So try that out if you're
not just like trying to store
and obtain metadata. The next
tool is a bit more advanced.
It's called textil Palghat gate,
and it's for you know, more
advanced developers or those
looking for more flexibility to
interact with IPFS live peer to
peer and filecoin. It's a Docker
container wrapped around
filecoin and IPFS nodes. And it
gives you a lot of options to
configure it's a minor
selections and extend
functionality. It also offers
some bridges to several layer
ones which might be of interest
to developers out there. Another
one here and I'll preface this
by saying you need an invite to
this is ESRI tech. So it's for
people looking to store really
meaningful public data. It's
currently in alpha mode and like
I said, it requires an invite
because it's been built as a
public goods specifically to
store important information. If
you are I do have Use case
around this slide, please feel
free to reach out to us on this
project. Other final tool I'll
mention is orbit dB. So many
people coming to the web three
space from web two are often
looking for the same sort of
relational databases that we're
so used to in traditional
computing except in a
decentralized or distributed
format. And this isn't an easy
problem. So Oba to me is
currently in active development.
And because this isn't an easy
problem to solve, this isn't an
ideal solution for those of you
looking for an out of the box
experience. But if you are
looking for something like that,
try out orbit dB. And there's
also several other tools in the
ecosystem leveraging IPFS and
filecoin, including ceramic,
which is similar to textil power
gate, except it uses
decentralized identities.
Lighthouse is file drive, and
there's even Morales has an IPFS
API, so check those out as well.
So storage is really a
fundamental component on one
technology system. So and
there's so many use cases you
could dive into here. And so
hopefully, I've provided you
with some of the knowledge and
tools you need to get started
with IPFS and file Goyt. Coin
and really make powerful
distributed applications. And
there's just one more tool
that's also in active
development now. So if you look
closely at this diagram, you'll
notice probably unfamiliar logo
right at the end of the logic
layer. And that's the logo for
the filecoin virtual machine. So
FBM will be launching at the end
of this year. And we're super
excited about it. And it's going
to allow smart contracts,
contract use combined with like
colocation of storage data,
loads, so computing capabilities
with storage capabilities, and
will also be EVM compatible. So
as I said, we're super excited
for the kinds of use cases that
we're going to see come out of
this project as well. And you
can follow along here on the
website here as well. So
hopefully, I've given you all
the tools you need to get
started with IPFS. And file
coin. If you do need more
resources or want to get
involved, we have proto School,
which is interactive tutorials
on decentralized web protocols.
There's also NFT, school dot
Dev, or join a hackathon, check
out our hackathons.filecoin.io
page for all the latest
hackathons we're involved in.
And if you do really want to dig
deep and build tooling in IPFS,
and file coin or build a cool
project, check out our grants
options as well for that, in the
meantime, all please learn long
build and prosper.
So we've learned a ton in this
section. And that is it. So
let's do a summary of all the
amazing things that we've
learned. And then we'll go into
the TypeScript edition of this
because the TypeScript edition
is definitely a little bit
different. So let's talk.
Alright, so first, we learned
more about next Jas. And we
learned we can have an
application using next Jas. And
it's a framework that's gonna
allow us to build really
powerful front ends and full
stack applications really
easily. We learned about the
layout of our next JS project,
we add components in a
components folder, which are
basically minimalistic blocks of
JavaScript and HTML that we can
use to modularize and create our
website out of these components.
Constants is a folder that we
can put constant variables, Node
modules is node modules. And out
folders. What happens when we
export all of our code to a
static example, pages are going
to be basically the routes or
the different pages of our
website, everything goes through
app.js. Public is just some
public stuff styles is for any
CSS or styling of our
application. And then we have
our basic files here. In our
pages section, we have our app,
which is surrounded by both this
notification provider and our
Morales provider, all of our
components run through this app
on all of our pages run through
this app. So this is kind of
considered the entry point for
our entire application. Having
this Morales provider wrapped
around our notifications in
component means that we don't
have to pass parameters between
our components. And our lottery
will just know what chain ID
that we're on, because our
header is going to pass it up to
Morales provider and the Morales
provider is going to pass it
back down to our lottery
entrance. And we saw with our
manual header, the way that that
connect button works behind the
scenes. So it's doing some local
storage, where we're storing
whether or not we're actually
connected, we learned about use
effect, and you state and these
different hooks in our front
ends were one of the main
reasons we want hooks is we want
we want our websites to
rerender. When stuff changes, we
want our components to be able
to talk about the state of the
blockchain with each other. And
they're incredibly powerful for
building our React applications.
Use effect is one of the most
popular ones where if we don't
have a dependency array, our
function inside of our use
effect will run anytime
something re renders a blank
dependency array means it'll
just run once on load. And if
there are dependencies in the
array, it'll run any time any of
the variables in those change.
We also learned about the use
state hook, which is really
similar to saying like, let
variable equals x. But it also
comes with the RE rendering
ability. And it comes with some
other nice abilities that we
didn't really discuss here, we
learned how to call different
contract functions with
mirallas. Not only sending
transactions, but also calling
data. Morales is smart enough to
know that when it sees get
entrance fee that this is going
to be a view function. And this
is going to be a transaction, it
can tell the difference between
the two. So this one's going to
populate Metamask to pop up. And
this one just going to return
kind of normally like a view
function, what we can actually
use the same syntax between
sending transactions and then
calling view functions on our
contract, we added a button,
calling one of these Morales
pieces and then had an onsuccess
section where when our
transaction completed, we update
the UI and we add a little pop
up for notifications, we learned
how to deploy our code directly
to IPFS. And use that IPFS hash
to interact and see our code, we
also learned about fleek and how
fleek automatically deploys to
IPFS. Whenever we do a git push
to our GitHub repository, and it
makes continuously updating our
websites much easier. It also
gives us a regular canonical URL
as well. And then finally, we
learned about IPFS and
decentralized database storage.
Now you might be asking, Okay,
well, why don't we just store
all the data for this website on
Aetherium, or polygon or
avalanche, etc? And the answer
to that is that can get
incredibly expensive storing
data, storing a ton of data on
the blockchain costs a ton of
gas, whereas this is a much
cheaper alternative. Aetherium
avalanche and the smart contract
platforms aren't really meant to
be data storage layers, they're
meant to be logic layers, right?
Decentralized logic,
decentralized smart contracts,
oftentimes, yes, we're gonna
have to store data in them. But
when it's a ton of data, there
are better solutions. And there
are different solutions out
there for storing our data, like
IPFS and filecoin, you should be
incredibly proud of yourself, if
you've made it this far, because
you've just made a really solid
app, a really solid front end
application. And you've learned
how to really easily add
functionality for interacting
with your smart contracts. So
give yourself a pat on the back,
maybe even tweet this out, share
this really cool application
with your friends and family.
Take a break. And I'll see you
in the next lesson.
All right, welcome to one of the
fastest lessons that we're going
to have here. And in this
lesson, we're going to talk
about the hardhat starter kit.
Really quickly, I'm going to
walk you through it and show you
how to use it. Now we've learned
a lot about projects, we've
learned a lot about different
repos, learnt the basics of
smart contracts. And we've
learned a lot about front end as
well and building front ends for
applications. So this smart
contract kit repo comes packed
with a ton of starter kits that
you can use to start deploying
your projects right away. And as
you can see, that hard hat
starter kit is easily one of the
most popular ones with the most
stars the most forks out there.
The smart contract kit repo
actually comes with a ton of
frameworks, like if you want to
work with SWANA, if you want to
work with Python and Brownie, if
you want to work with foundry,
truffle, really any other
framework out there, you can get
started, clone one of these
repos, work with one of these
repos and build your project and
get started right away, we're
going to show you how to use the
hard hat starter kit. So you can
just grab the repo and go and
already have some boilerplate
code and a boilerplate really
good looking repo to start your
projects with, we come to the
smart contract kit, hard hat
starter kit repo here. And if
you're working with GitHub, you
can just go ahead and use this
template and it will
automatically generate you a new
GitHub repo with the hardest
starter kit. So let's go ahead,
we'll click use this template,
we come up with our own name
here, we'll call it make it
public create repository from
Template. it'll generate our
repository. And now we
automatically have it in our own
repo here. And we can get
started working with it. And we
can get started working with it.
If you don't want to click the
use that template button, we can
also just copy the URL. And in
our code editor, we can just do
git clone and paste that in
there. So for now, I am going to
get clone, but I'm going to get
clone with this repo that we
just created. Come back in with
the git clone, hard hat play FCC
or hard hat starter kit. We're
going to cd into our head play
FCC, and then open that up in a
new code editor. And awesome.
Now you'll see in this repo, it
comes packed with a ton of
contracts, deployments, scripts,
tasks, test, everything, you
name it to really get started in
a professional environment. We
look in the contract section, we
can see we have a couple of
sample contracts. We have a
contract for making an API call
to a chain link node, working
with keepers working with price
feeds, and then working with
chain link Vir Fe two. We've got
some test contracts and we
additionally have this fuzzing
folder, which we'll talk talk
about in a much later section of
this course, we have deployed
scripts where we start with
deploying mocks, then we deploy
each one of those contracts, we
have a sample script to read the
price from one of these
contracts. And we have a whole
bunch of sample tasks. Now at
the time of recording, instead
of scripts, this repo uses
tasks. But again, they're a
little bit interchangeable. And
of course, we have some unit
tests and some staging tests as
well, that you can go through
and take a look at, once we're
in this repo, we can run some
familiar commands here, we'll do
yarn, of course, to install our
all of our packages. And then
everything that we're going to
do, if you get lost, you can
always come back to this repo.
And you can follow along with
getting started and the
Quickstart. So we just did the
git clone. Now we're doing the
yarn, and then we're gonna go
ahead and run yarn hard hat
test. This hard hat starter kit
repo is very consistently up to
date, we did the last push being
just a few days ago, and will
constantly have some best
practices for building our smart
contracts and having a really
professional coding environment.
And it's got this really cute
logo. Once we've installed all
the dependencies, we can run
yarn, art hath test, we can run
all of the tests in the test
folder, which also will show us
how to interact and how to use
all these different contracts in
here. And they each have some
console dot log, so you can see
more about what's actually going
on when these tests actually
run. If we look in the Hardhead
config.js, it's got some really
familiar code in here, we have
all our imports at the top, we
grab a whole bunch of
environment variables, we've got
the ether scan plugin, we've got
the gas reporter, the contract
sizer, which is a plugin that
tells you how big your contracts
are. So named accounts,
different solidity versions, and
then mocha timeout as well. We
can of course, do yarn hard hat
node, which will run through our
deploy scripts, and then spin up
a new note for us, which has
mock chainlink tokens, mock
Oracle's mock aggregators, and
mock up VRF for us to go ahead
and interact with once that's
up, we can then of course, to
hard hat, console, dash dash
network localhost, and begin
interacting with contracts on
localhost. So we can kind of
follow along with price feed,
for example, and do const price
consumer B three equals await
ethers dot get contract, price,
consumer V three.
And then we can do await price
consumer B three dot get latest
price. Let's wrap that in a to
string. And we can see a mock
latest price from a contract
that uses channeling price
feeds. And we can interact with
any of our contracts and work
with any of the mocks as well in
here. If we want to deploy this
to an actual test net like
Rinckey, or main net will just
pop in our dot env file, we'll
close our node terminal, and we
can run yarn hardhat or just hh
deploy. And then we'll add
whatever tags we want to do
here. So let's just deploy our
price feed contract. If we go to
the price feed deploy, we scroll
down, we'll get the tags. Okay,
great, we'll use the feed tag,
dash tags feeds dash to or feed
dash dash network brings beam.
And while we're waiting for this
to deploy, we can go back to the
actual repo. And just make sure
to follow along with the
documentation here and the
Quickstart in all the usage and
everything so that you make sure
that you're working with the
most up to date version. There's
even documentation on running a
local network using a test net
or live network working with
Aetherium. Rigby adding your
private keys and dotting envies
all this stuff that you already
know, forking, which we'll learn
a little bit later, auto funding
your contracts for working with
chain link API running tests,
you can additionally run your
tests in parallel by adding the
dash dash parallel flag to our
tests. We can interact with our
deployed contracts with those
different tasks that we've
created linting code formatting,
estimated gas code coverage
fuzzing, we'll talk about later.
And then contributions. PRs
issues are always welcome here.
And once it's outputted, and
even verified, if you have
verification turned on, you'll
get a little task that we can
run to just go ahead and read
the price feed or interact with
the contract. So we can copy
that task out. Yarn hardhat.
Read price feed since it's a
task here, contract the contract
data which we just deployed
network Rigby. And we'll get
reading data price feed from
consumer contract on network,
Rigby price is here, which of
course, we're saying the price
of Aetherium is $3,033, because
it has eight decimal places. So
if you're ever looking to start
a new project, and you want some
boilerplate code, this hard hat
Starter Kit is a great place to
get started. And of course, you
can open it and get pod if you
want to just test it out and try
it and get pot in a Cloud Shell.
So that's it for this lesson.
Wasn't that fast. This was the
fastest lesson ever. So if you
want to do a little extra
learnings here, I would fork
this I would clone this I would
use this template, try to play
around with the repo a little
bit yourself and see what you
recognize, see what you don't
recognize and keep that prepped
in your mind for later so
Questions in the course. And
then for everyone here who is
TypeScript, there is, of course,
a TypeScript version of this as
well that you can get cloned.
And it has a nice blue logo here
to show that it's a little bit
different. So, that being said,
use the repo, have fun. Let's
get to lesson 12.
Alright, now we're moving on to
the hard hat ERC. 20s are the
section where we're going to
learn how to create our own ERC
20 or EIP 20 Or B E P 20 or AEP
20 any of these tokens on the
blockchain before we can
understand what an ERC 20 is, or
even what one of these tokens
are, we first need to understand
what is an ERC. And then also
what is an EIP in Aetherium, and
avalanche and finance and
polygon. All these blockchains
have what's called improvement
proposals. And for Aetherium,
they're called Aetherium
improvement proposals, or E IPs.
And what people would do is they
come up with these ideas to
improve Aetherium or improve
these layer ones like polygon,
Matic avalanche, etc. And on
some GitHub or some open source
repository, they'll add these
new EIP is they'll add these new
improvement ideas to make these
protocols better. Now, these
improvements can really be
anything, they can be anything
from a core blockchain update to
some standard, that is going to
be a best practice for the
entire community to adopt. Once
an EIP gets enough insight, they
also create an E RC, which
stands for Aetherium request for
comments. So EIP a theory and
improvement proposals ERC a
theory and request for comments.
And again, these can be like BP,
Pep, you know, etc. For all
these different blockchains.
Both the improvement proposals
and the Request for Comments,
all have these different tags,
now they're numbered
chronologically, so something
like an ERC 20 is going to be
the 20th ERC slash EIP, the ERC
is and the EFPs share that same
number. And there are websites
like EIP is that aetherium.org
That keep track of all of these
new Aetherium improvement
proposals, and you can actually
see them real time go through
the process of being adopted by
the community. Now, one of these
e IPs or ERC is, is going to be
the ERC 20 or the token standard
for smart contracts. This is an
improvement proposal that talks
about how to actually create
tokens and create these smart
contract tokens. I made a video
about this recently. So in the
GitHub repo associated with this
course, we're going to have a
sub lesson, and we're going to
watch a quick video that
explains more about these
different tokens. Now first,
let's define even what are ERC
20s So ERC 20s are tokens that
are deployed on a chain using
what's called the ERC 20 token
standard, you can read more
about it in the year 20 token
standard here link in the
description as well. But
basically, it's a smart contract
that actually represents a
token. So it's token or the
smart contract. It's both it's
really cool tether chainlink
unique token and dye are all
examples of ERC 20s Technically,
chain link is in the ERC. 677 as
there are upgrades to the ERC 20
that some tokens take that are
still backwards compatible with
ERC. 20s And so basically, you
can think of them as ERC 20s
with a little additional
functionality. Now why would I
even care to want to make an ERC
20 Well, you can do a lot of
really cool stuff with it. You
can make governance token, you
can secure an underlying
network, you can create some
type of synthetic acid, or
really anything else. In any
case, how do we build one of
these ERC? 20s How do we build
one of these tokens? Well, all
we have to do is build a smart
contract that follows the token
standard, all we have to do is
build a smart contract that has
these functions that has a name
function, symbol function,
decimals function, etc. All
these functions we need to be
able to transfer it, we need to
be able to get the balance of it
etc. And again, if you want to
check out some of the
improvements that are still ERC
20 compatible, like the ERC 677
or the ERC 777. Definitely go
check those out and build one of
those instead. All right,
awesome. Now that we know what
one of these ERC 20s is, we can
go ahead and create our own per
usual in the GitHub repo
associated with this course. We
have all the code available
here. If you want to just get
clone. This is going to be again
another one of our quicker
lessons here. So we're in our
terminal. We're in our VS code
here. We're going to make a new
directory. I'm going to call it
hard hat ERC 20 FCC will cd into
hard hat, your C 20 sec. And
we're going to create a new hard
hat project the exact same way
we've been doing it yarn add
dash dash dev or tab. Let's
actually open it in its own VS
code will do code.or file open
this folder. And okay, we're in
our project now. Let's create a
new hard hat project. We'll do
yarn, art hats.
We'll do create an empty hard
hat dot config dot j s here and
great. We've now got an empty
hard hat dot config dot j s. If
you want to copy paste your hard
hat dot config from a previous
projects you want to copy paste
your heart Have dot config or
your dot EMV file, because you
know we're going to need those
feel free to do so now, I'm just
going to update this to 8.7.
I'll add the rest of my stuff
later. So as we've heard this
EIP 20, or this ERC 20. All it
needs is to have these functions
in its token standard so that we
can transfer tokens, we can do
all the stuff in the ERC 20
contract itself, it really is
just keeping track of how much
of each token people have. So
the smart contract, kind of in a
weird way it keeps track of
itself. To get started, we're
going to do this kind of the
manual way. First, we're going
to create our own manual token
here, or a really minimalistic
one anyways, so let's create a
new folder. contracts will
create a new file called manual
token dot soul. Yes, I'm going
to show you kind of the hard way
to make it and then I'll show
you a much easier way to make
it. So to get started here are
usual we can do pragma, solidity
to carrot zero, point 8.7. And
then we'll even do spdx, license
identifier, MIT do contract,
manual token, and boom, let's
get started. The main reason
this token smart contract works
is that there's some balances
mapping. So we have a mapping of
addresses to you in 256. And
it's usually public called
balance of and all this does is
this mapping is obviously the
key is going to be every single
address on the planet, and then
how much they have. And
basically, when we transfer
tokens, transfer tokens, we're
basically just subtract from
address, amount, and add to to
address. So a really
minimalistic way to implement
this would be to create this
transfer function first. So
we'll create this function, I'm
going to call it underscore
transfer, we can do an address
from address to you into fifth
sixth mount. And now we'd
probably put some requirements,
we probably omit some events,
and let's make this public as
well. And really, at the end of
the day, is we're gonna say
balance of from minus equals
value, which is the same as
saying bounce of from equals
bounce from minus value, or
excuse me, amount, and then
we're gonna say balance of two,
excuse me, plus equals, which is
the same as saying, you know,
balance of two plus. And
technically, that's really all
we need, right, we probably want
to do some asserts ins here,
some requires to make sure all
of our numbers make sense. But
really, at the end of the day,
this is all that this function
is doing. Transfer works when
the caller is sending money
directly into another address.
But what happens if we want to
allow some smart contract to
work with our token, or we want
to allow somebody else to work
with our token, you know, maybe
to deposit it into a protocol,
or do some more functionality
with it, there will be some
approved function that will
approve that contract to do
that. And then we'll have a
function transfer from and this
function will, you know, it'll
just implement taking funds from
user and this will be public as
well. And then at the top will
be some type of allowances
mapping that will tell who's
allowed which address to take
how much token, which sounds a
little confusing, but let me
just add the mapping. So it'll
be a mapping of addresses to a
mapping of addresses to an
amount to a unit tivity sex and
this will be public allowance,
we're gonna say address, Patrick
is going to allow address of
Patrick's brother to use 25
tokens. And that's how this
allowance works. And in our
transfer from transfer from will
check this allowance mapping and
save Hmm. Did Patrick give you
authorization to borrow those
tokens? Oh, yes, you did. Okay,
we'll let you transfer from. And
I'm just, I'm just going to copy
paste an implementation of it,
you can check out the GitHub
repo as well. And it would look
something like this is we check
the allowed amounts, update the
allowance, and then transfer the
tokens. So those are some of the
main functions. So we need an
approved function, obviously, to
update the allowances here. And
usually, you'll have like a un
256 initial supply. And this
will be like how many tokens
there are starting with how many
tokens there are total,
sometimes you'll add a mint
function to add more functions.
But you can basically start to
see this contract ramping up.
One thing we could do is we
could go ahead go through this
spec and just line by line, you
know, build our token ourself.
And after we do that, it might
look something like this. So I'm
just copy pasted the code from
the GitHub repo. If you go to
contracts, manual token, I just
copy paste this code in here.
This is what a contract a token
contract might look like. Okay.
So we have all these functions,
we have all these arrays. We
have all this stuff. And you can
see in the constructor, we're
taking initial supply, and then
a token name and a token symbol.
The name, you know, might be
something like dy token. And
then the symbol might be
something like dy, just so that
it's easily recognizable just by
its name and its token.
coding it all from scratch, like
that is definitely something
that we can do. But as
engineers, we know that that's
probably really annoying. And we
don't actually want to do that.
So what can we do instead? Well,
we can use an open source
library, like open Zeppelin, to
actually get some boilerplate
code work with open Zeppelin is
almost considered kind of the
standard library of solidity.
They have a list of open source
contracts that anybody can use
and import into their contracts
that have a ton of boilerplate,
so that you don't have to
manually write everything out,
we can see all their code in
their GitHub repository, open
Zeppelin slash open Zeppelin
contracts, and we're going to be
using them a lot moving forward.
So for example, you can see kind
of on the left side of their
documentation, they have this
tokens section, and they have an
ERC 20, which is one of those
tokens standards. If you scroll
on here, they even have some
minimalistic examples of how to
create your own ERC 20 token.
And that's what we're going to
be using to build our token.
Because you see how much smaller
this is how much less code this
is to maintain. Let's go ahead
and let's use open Zeppelin for
us to create our token. So let's
create a new file. We'll call
our token dot soul. I'm going to
create our own token here. So
let's do spdx. License
identifier, MIT, we'll do
pragma, solidity carrot zero,
point 8.7, we'll do contract our
token. Now, what we're going to
do, we're going to import
openzeppelin contracts into our
hard hat project. And we're
going to do it the same way we
did with chain link and any
other packages in the future. So
we'll do yarn, add dash dash
Dev, at open Zeppelin slash
contracts. And this is going to
add the open Zeppelin slash
contracts NPM package to our
project. And one of the code
pieces that they have is this
ERC 20 contract that we can use
and we can have our token
inherit all the functions. So
we'll go ahead and import it
with import at openzeppelin.
Slash contracts slash tokens
slash ERC 20 slash ERC 20
ditzel. And just by importing it
like this, all we have to do is
have our token inherited now. So
we'll say contract. Our token is
ERC 20. Boom. And just like that
our token is almost done. Now
you might get this little wiggle
this little red line here saying
our token should be marked
abstract. And that's because if
we look into the ERC 20 dot soul
of openzeppelin We'll see that
it has a constructor. So in
order for us to inherit your C
20 token, we have to use the ERC
20 constructor and we just need
to give our token a name and a
symbol. But we can say in our
constructor, we can leave it
blank. And then right next to
our constructor, we'll add the
ERC 20 constructor and our name
will be our token. And then our
symbol will just be OT and then
this ERC. 20 token also comes
with something called a mint
functionality, which is
essentially a function that
allows us to create tokens,
right because right now we
actually get initialized with
zero tokens, right. So nobody's
actually allowed to have any
tokens. So we want to mint the
initial amount of tokens and
then who owns all those tokens
to start with. So usually what
you'll see is you'll see a mint
function like this, it'll be
passed in message that sender,
so whoever deploys this contract
will own all the tokens to
start. And then we'll give it
like an in their soul supply.
And then we could do like, you
went to 56 initial supply equals
like seven, or whatever. But
instead, a common practice is
just to add it to the
constructor. So you and 256
initial supply like that, as we
know about solidity decimals
don't work so great. So if I say
my initial supply is 50, that 50
is going to be like 50 way, and
there's all these ERC 20s come
with a decimals and decimals
function, which tells us how
many decimals we should expect
with our ERC 20. The default is
18. And we can override this
function if we want a different
amount of decimals. And if we
know the default is 18. And we
want to deploy 50, we might want
to do our initial supply of 50 e
18. Or you can also say like 50
times 10, raise the 18th or
whatever you want there. And in
our code when we deploy this
now, this is actually where
we're going to finish the
project. Because everything else
that we would do here, we've
already done, all we need to do
is make a deploy script and
write some tests. That's really
it. Because right now you have
all the skills that you need to
write a deploy script and then
optionally write some tests for
this project. So I highly
encourage you to pause the video
here and try to write your own
deploy script. And even if you
want to write your own tests,
you can always refer back To the
GitHub repo associated with this
lesson, as we do have a deploy
script in here, we also have a
TypeScript edition in here as
well that we're additionally not
going to go over. And of course,
if you get totally lost, there's
a ton of instructions in here to
help you learn more and help you
work with this specific
repository.
So let's do a quick review of
what we just learned. So ERC 20
tokens, or EIP 20 tokens or or b
p or p p, or any of these dash
20. Improvement proposals are
what's known as the token
standard. And the token
standard, these tokens on chain
actually just tokens that are
smart contracts. Now, these
tokens are obviously different
than the layer one tokens like
Aetherium, or polygon or
Avalanche or arbitration, those
are not going to be smart
contracts, those are going to be
blockchain native tokens, and
you'll hear me refer to it as
blockchain native tokens a lot.
versus these tokens, these ERC
20, these smart contract tokens,
which are just smart contracts.
And they're just kind of a
combination of these functions
that represent how many tokens
each address has, we can create
our own token with all the
specifications added. Or we can
just use openzeppelin to import
a token in now another popular
repo like open Zeppelin is going
to be this one from Rory capital
called soulmate. And they're
both aimed to be standard
libraries for solidity. And one
of the important things to keep
in mind is that these tokens
have this allowance mapping. And
you can allow other addresses to
have access to your tokens and
move your tokens around. This is
important, especially when we
get to later on when working
with defy when we want to give
some smart contract access to
our tokens so that they can
input it into their defy
protocol. It's also a little bit
tricky. And you want to make
sure you're not allowing
malicious contracts to interact
with your tokens. And we'll also
see that when we start to
interact with these tokens more
before any contract can interact
with our tokens, we need to
approve them to interact with
our tokens. And that's it. Now
you're a token wizard, and you
can deploy your own tokens. Take
a break, get that coffee, and
I'll see you in the next one.
All right, welcome to the next
session, we are going to be
learning about defy in this
session and going to be
programmatic, and going to be
programmatically interacting
with the defy protocol. I am
incredibly excited for you for
this session, because defi is
one of the best use cases for
smart contracts. And one of the
use cases that I am specifically
most excited for now, as I've
mentioned, the past defy stands
for decentralized finance, we've
left some links in the GitHub
repository for you to learn more
about Defy. One of the main
reasons we're so excited about
defy is because we move away
from this area of traditional
agreement. And that's what smart
contracts are all about. They're
about removing this centralized
entity, from our financial
world, and especially from these
financial institutions that have
a conflict of interest. They're
in business to make money not to
keep our money safe not to make
us money. And we want to work
with a system where everything
is transparent, especially when
it comes to our financial
services. So we want to move to
this world of smart contracts,
especially when it comes to our
money. And in my mind, defi is
going to be the industry that
affects the masses, the quickest
because of how much fair how
much better decentralized
finance is than centralized
finance. And at the moment, the
rates and the yields and the
interest that you gain in defy
is much better than centralized
finance, because remember, will
go away from these centralized
protocols, saying, hey, trust
us, we'll give you access to the
markets or hate trust us put
your money in us will keep your
money safe to this cryptographic
math base guarantees instead of
having to trust these companies
and these entities, which is
what we want. And additionally,
the more our Oracle networks get
better, and the more Oracle's
networks work with these smart
contract platforms like
Aetherium, like polygon, like
arbitrage them, the more data
and the more complex financial
products that we can do. Now,
one of the other reasons I'm so
crazy excited about defy is if
you look at this little chart
right here, it shows the
different markets by size. Now
this this image is a little bit
outdated, but it still shows you
the relative sizes of all these
different industries defy right
now is a $200 billion market,
there's about $200 billion
locked in the defy industry. And
I'll show you that in a minute.
Cryptocurrency actually, at the
time of recording isn't 360
billion. It's actually like 1.8
trillion. So it's a lot more
than this. But still, it's a
massive subset of all these
other areas like gold is a $10
trillion market. The stock
market is almost $100 trillion
global real estate, almost $300
trillion derivatives as
quadrillion dollars. So the FBI
is a super tiny, tiny, tiny,
tiny subset right now and in my
mind, all of these areas can be
re landscaped with Defy. So
we're ramping up, we're getting
there. So it's gonna be up to us
to make some of these protocols
and make it Much easier for
people to get into the space
where their finances are going
to be more fair, more
accountable and more
transparent. And with better
yield rates, we can actually see
a pretty good summary of what's
going on in defy this site
called defy llama. It shows
total value locked in all these
different decentralized
protocols. And we can see a lot
of these are across multiple
chains, right. And a lot of
these are EVM compatible chains,
Aetherium, Biden, smart chain,
avalanche, Fanta, drawn polygon,
all these are EVM, compatible
blockchains, where we can see
exactly how much money
independent users have put into
these protocols. The time of
recording Ave is the number one
protocol for total value locked.
So there's $22 billion locked in
Ave, which is the protocol that
we're going to be going over
today.
So what is Ave So are they is a
borrowing and lending protocol,
it allows us to borrow and lend
cryptocurrencies. So we can
actually put down a token as
collateral, it's kind of similar
to like putting money in a bank,
and earn yields on other people
borrowing that collateral from
us almost exactly what a bank
does, except for the fact it's
what's called noncustodial. To
the Ave team never touches our
money. Nobody ever touches the
money. It's all just a smart
contract. It's all just this
programmatic code. So we can be
rest assured, no one's going to
run off with our money, no one's
going to do anything bad. And we
also gain these higher yields.
borrowing and lending is a
critical piece for creating
really any interesting financial
applications. If you want to
short sell something, if you
want to leverage up on some
asset if you want to. If you
want to do more complex
financial products, you need
borrowing and lending. Now a lot
of the typical FinTech or
financial technology or finance
terms do apply here. And this
course isn't going to be a deep
dive into exactly how these
financial products work. And
it's also not going to be a
course on finance. If you want
to learn more about finance,
we'll leave a number of links in
our GitHub repo associated with
this course. So you can learn
more about finance and become
what I like to call a defy
quant, quantitative defy
engineer. And I am so excited
for more defi quants to get into
this space. Alright, so here we
are in the Ave application. It's
at testament dot Ave dot
markets, we are in the testament
of Avi now, everything that
we're going to do here is going
to work on Main net as well, but
we're going to use it on their
test net. Now this is actually
obvious older UI, and they have
a new website that looks even
better than this. But we're
going to be going through a lot
of the basic functionality
depositing taking out a loan,
potentially even shorting an
asset, if we want, I don't
recommend going to the site
because it might not work and
COVID the way you'd expect it
to. So for this, just sit back,
relax and watch. In order for us
to actually short sell or margin
trade. The first thing that
we're going to need to do is
actually deposit some
collateral, we need to deposit
some collateral in order to
borrow this way. If we never
repay back the loan that we took
out or the the amount that we
borrowed, Ave, we'll just go
ahead and take the collateral
that we put in here, we'll do
what's called a liquidation
call. And that's why this is
actually a little bit safer than
short selling in traditional
markets. Because if your
collateral is less than how much
you have borrowed, you'll just
immediately get liquidated, but
you still lose a bunch of money
so like don't get liquidated. So
what we want to do now is we're
gonna scroll to Aetherium, we're
going to connect our wallet
here, we're going to move to
COVID test network browser here.
And we're gonna go to this
deposit piece. So it already
shows our balance here we have
point two COVID eath. Let's
deposit 0.1.
We're gonna hit deposit Metamask
can pop up, confirm. But once
this goes through, this means
that we've have it deposited and
we go to our dashboard, we can
see we have some eath here,
point one eath got some API,
this is kind of like that
percentage return that we're
gonna get back for, for
depositing into Ave. And yes, we
can use it as collateral here,
we have this, this marked as yes
here. So that's exactly what
we're going to do. And it says
nothing borrowed. Yep, we can go
ahead and hit this borrow now
button. And we're gonna get
brought to the borrower screen,
and we're going to choose which
asset we want to borrow. Now,
whenever we borrow one of these,
there are these API's, right?
This is the percentage that over
the course of a year that we're
gonna have to pay, in order to
actually borrow this asset. The
stable one means it'll always be
for or variable means it
actually changes depending on
kind of how much liquidity the
protocol has, you can kind of
pick which one you want to do
stable is you're always gonna be
a 4% variable is going to be a
little bit riskier, but you
might get a lower fee. So we're
actually going to borrow some
dye right, because dye is a
stable coin. It's worth $1. In a
way, you could call this taking
out on margin because we're
taking out dye to borrow and
another way we could say we're
shorting dye which is kind of
funny to think about, but you
get to choose how much you want
to borrow here and you'll see
this this thing called Health
factor I'm going to zoom in a
little bit this thing called
Health factor here as we as we
scroll this thing. So this
health factor is how close to
being liquidated you are
remember how I said you can get
liquidated this health factor
represents how close we are to
getting liquidated. This means
means how close we are to always
saying, You know what fu we're
taking your funds. If it goes
below one at any time, somebody
can liquidate you and take a lot
of that deposit that we put in,
there's some math behind
actually what the health factor
actually is, you can head over
to the Ave documentation, which
I will leave a link in the
description to kind of read more
about the health factor. So
we're going to borrow 29 die
we're buying, we're borrowing
basically 30 bucks. Gonna hit
continue, I'm gonna do a
variable, zoom back out,
continue, we're gonna borrow
metamath pops up, confirm
transaction that's pending. And
we're gonna go to the dashboard.
And now we can see kind of our
new balance here, right, we can
see the point one eath,
deposited and 29 die. And we can
see our health factor up here,
you can even click this little
button, saying, hey, it
represents how close you are to
being liquidated, we can see the
value here, our eath is worth
like $200, or die is worth 30
bucks. So we're good. We're
pretty healthy here. In order
for Avi to understand and under
to price the underlying
collateral, so it knows how much
it can lend out. Obviously
another one of these protocols
that uses changing price feeds
to price, the underlying
collateral, many of these
billion dollar defy protocols
use chain link on the back end
to do all their pricing
mechanisms. And that's
essentially it, we could then
repay our debts, we could borrow
more assets, we could swap
assets around. And the interest
return, we get onto pausing our
assets is amazing. So now that
we learned a little bit about
how to use their UI, which is
hosted on IPFS, by the way,
let's go ahead and let's learn
how to do all this and do even
more programmatically so we can
become defy quanta engineers.
Now, like I said, we're going to
be working with the Ave v two
protocol, if you want to try out
the v3, you absolutely can, if
you can go there and play with
it right now, it still has more
money locked in it, which is
great. But the v3 protocol is
obviously the latest addition.
So we're gonna be flipping back
and forth between the
documentation and our code base.
So I recommend that you have the
documentation up as well. And
per usual, all of the code that
we're going to be working with
is in this hard hat defi Free
Code Camp repository. So let's
jump in. I'm in by VS code, I'm
in my folder with this course,
we're going to make a new
folder, we're going to call it
hard hat, defy FCC, we're going
to cd into it. And then we're
going to open it up with code
period. Or you can also do per
usual, File Open and then open
that folder. Now we're in a new
project, we're going to do yarn,
add dash dash Dev, aren't hat.
And we're going to add hard hat
and start up our minimalistic
hard hat project. Once again,
for starting up your
minimalistic hard hat projects,
I usually just copy paste from
another folder, or I just used
that hard hat starter kit that
we saw in the smart contract
code repo. But whatever works
best for you to get your project
started, you can use now that
we've got this, we can run yarn
hardhat. And we'll just create
an empty hardhat.config.js. Now
to save us some boilerplate
time, I am going to copy paste
my hard hat.config.js from a
past project into this one, just
to make it so we don't have to
go through that boilerplate
setup again. And I'm also going
to copy paste this line from our
heart at smart contract lottery.
Again, if you want to use your
package JSON or your yarn dot
lock to install dependencies,
you absolutely can. But I'm just
going to paste that in here and
run it. And then I'm going to
copy paste over my prettier
files, so that all my JavaScript
can be formatted the way I want
it to be. Okay, great. Now we
have a minimalistic project spun
up, let's go ahead and get
started learning how to interact
with the AVI protocol here. So
let's make a quick readme and
talk about what we want to be
able to do. So first, we're
going to want to be able to
learn how to programmatically
deposit collateral. And if we
stopped right there, that might
be enough, we'd be able to
programmatically deposit
collateral, and in doing so we
earn yield, we'd earn that
percentage return just on our
deposited collateral. So
accomplishing this by itself is
already a feat. But let's say we
want to go one step further, we
want to get into these more
interesting financial products.
So after we deposit some
collateral, we're going to learn
how to programmatically borrow
and other asset, the deposited
collateral is going to be eath,
slash wrapped eath, which we'll
talk about in a little bit,
we're going to borrow another
asset, which for this demo is
going to be dye. And the reason
that we're using dye is because
dye is what's known as a stable
coin. So dye is actually a token
on the blockchain created by
this maker Dow where the price
of the dye token is always
pegged to $1. So we're putting
down eath as collateral and
we're borrowing cryptocurrency,
US dollars, sort of, we're
borrowing this token, which
represents a US dollar and then
we'll just repay that I will
repay almost everything back and
you'll see why we don't repay
everything back in a minute. One
other protocol that I want to
talk about quickly is the
uniswap protocol. And the
uniswap protocol has become this
haven for trading. It's a
decentralized application that
allows us to trade assets and
tokens with each other on
something called an automated
market maker. It ends basically
a decentralized Stock Exchange,
but with tokens and again,
tokens aren't exactly stocks,
they're very different. So when
looking to get some of these
assets It's like wrapped
Aetherium or dye or link token.
On a main net, oftentimes,
you're going to use one of these
decentralized exchanges. And
obviously, these decentralized
exchanges are much fairer,
because everything that happens
on them is transparent, much
fairer than centralized finance,
everything that happens on them
is transparent. You can see
everything that's going on on
chain, which is absolutely
phenomenal. So let's go ahead
and get started here. And let's
just create our scripts folder.
Because in this project, we're
actually not going to create any
contracts ourselves, we're just
going to learn how to interact
with these protocols. If you do
want to learn how to build some
of these protocols, at the end
of this session, we will give
you a ton of links. And we'll
have a special guest explain a
few different ways to learn how
to build more of these
decentralized protocols.
Although we've already built one
with our decentralized lottery,
which is fantastic. Let's create
some scripts here. And for all
of these things, deposit
collateral, borrow and repay.
We'll just put this all in a new
script called Ave borrow dot
Jas. So we're gonna do
everything in here. And since
this is a script, it's going to
have the same setup, as we've
seen before, right, so we're
gonna have this main thing
around an async function. Main,
and then we'll have our imports,
of course at the top. Now
something that's important to
note, go to avi, we go to the
protocol, we kind of read
through the docs, and eventually
we would find out the protocol
treats everything as an ERC 20
token. And but we know that
Aetherium or the native
blockchain token that you're
using, isn't an ERC 20 token.
And the reason that treats
everything like an ERC 20 token
is that it's just much easier,
right? If everything's using
this ERC 20 token standard, it's
much easier to send in and
interact with stuff.
On a lot of these protocols,
when we go to deposit Aetherium,
or polygon, or arbitrary marks
cetera, what actually happens is
they send your Aetherium through
like what's called a web
gateway, and swaps it for weath,
which stands for rapt ether. And
it's basically Aetherium. But in
an ERC 20 token contract, so
what we want to do is going to
do that same thing, we're gonna
skip kind of using this web
gateway. And we'll just get the
Web Token ourselves, and we'll
use that as collateral. So in
our script tag, I'm going to
make another file called Get
weath.js. And in here, we're
actually going to go ahead, and
we're going to build a script
that will deposit our token for
web token. Okay, so let's create
the script. And there's a link
to the web token on ether scan,
and on Main net in the GitHub
repo. And the way it works, is
you actually deposit Aetherium.
And in return, it'll give you
the web token on Rigby right
now, by deposit 0.05. Go ahead
and write I'm connected to ether
scan, I'll go ahead and write
this transaction, I'm gonna
drink pee. So I don't really
care if it's if it's the actual
contract or not, because it's
not real money. But I'm going to
deposit 0.05 eath. And after our
transaction goes through, we
copy the contract address, we
add this token to our Metamask
the same way we added link will
import tokens, paste the address
in here, add custom token,
import tokens will now see we
have some wet token in here, I
deposited 0.1 before so 0.1 plus
0.05, which is why it shows 0.15
Because I did it twice, well,
while I wasn't recording. So um,
but this is how you can get this
wet token into your contract.
And then anytime you want, you
can call this withdrawal
function. And you can withdraw
your Aetherium out of this and
do what's called Burn your wet
token. So when you swap back
from weath to Aetherium, you hit
this withdraw and boom, you
basically swap them back because
this contract itself right now
is holding your Aetherium token.
Pretty cool, right? So in our
get wet function, we're not
going to add this main thing
here, we're going to create get
West here just as kind of a
module and we're going to import
it into our Ave borrow. So we're
not going to do this this main
thing that you see here.
Instead, we're going to create
an async function called Get
Wes. And then below, we're going
to export it. So we'll do module
dot exports equals get weath.
And we're going to export it so
our Avi borrow can use this get
West script that we're creating
right now, let's add let's go
ahead and do this. Well, in
order to interact with a
contract, we're going to need an
account. So we can do const
deployer equals await get named
accounts, per usual. We'll do
const get name accounts equals
require hardhat. My VS code
automatically imported that
thank you VS code now. And now
we want to call the deposit
function on the west contract.
How do we call this deposit
function on the west contract?
Well, how do you call any
contract? Well, what do you
need? You need the ABI and then
you need the contract address.
Drill this in. You're always
going to be the API and the
contract address to interact
with the contract. We know that
if we give we know that if we
give our project the whole
contract, it'll get the API but
we also know If we just do the
interface, that's just as good,
it won't give us all the
functionality, but it will tell
it will give us the API, it will
tell our ethers, what functions
it can use. So we're going to
create a new folder, create our
contracts folder. And in here,
we're going to create a new
folder inside of that called
interfaces. And this is where
we're going to create our web
interface. Now a web interface
is going to be really similar to
an ERC 20 interface. So if you
want to go ahead and try to add
it yourself, feel free to do so.
Or what you can just do is you
can come to the GitHub repo
associated with this lesson,
come to iOS and just copy paste,
right, you'll see the functions
in here are exactly the same as
an ERC 20, allowance approved
balance of decimals named blah,
blah, with these additional
deposit and withdrawal
functions. So I'm going to copy
all this, move back over to my
hard hat project, we'll create a
new file, we'll call I left dot
soul. And just to note,
oftentimes, a good best practice
is to have interfaces, start
with eyes so that you know what
to interface and then we'll
paste it in here. Now in order
for this to compile, we'll need
to use 0.4 point 19 version of
solidity. So what we can do is
we can come over to our, our
head.config.js. We have solidity
compilers, version 0.07, or
whatever versions that you have
in here, we can add or just
replace. So I'm going to put a
comma here, version 0.4 point
19. Save. And now in order to
make sure we can get that API,
do yarn, hardhats compile, or hh
compiled, and great, we compile
this interface. So now we have
the ABI to interact with. Now
that we have the ABI, a little
check mark here, let's go ahead
and get the contract address.
But for reasons that we're going
to learn about very soon, we're
actually going to work just with
main net set of getting the
Rinkeby test and address, I'm
going to look up with main net,
we're going to find the web
token on Main net. So I'm going
to copy the address of main net.
And again, you can just grab
this address from the GitHub
repo associated with this lesson
as well. And for now, we're
gonna say check a little check
mark here, and paste the address
there. So now we're have the ABI
compiled from an interface, and
we have the contract address for
main net. But let's go ahead and
create this contract now. So we
can say const, iOS equals await
ethers dot and then we'll need
to import ethers from Hardhead
as well. Ethers dot get contract
at this is another one of these
functions on ethers, it allows
us to get a contract at a
specific address, we'll say get
contract app, we use the iOS ABI
for now, we'll just hard code
this address in here. And then
we'll connect it to the
Deployer. So we're saying let's
get this web contract with the
ABI of iOS at this address
connected to Deployer. So we
could go ahead and run await AI
with dot deposit. And we'll set
value which will be some
amounts. Let's go ahead and at
the top, we'll say const amount
equals let's do ethers dot utils
dot parse, ether, and then we'll
do 0.0 0.02. So we'll deposit
0.02 will say const TX equals
that will do await TX dot wait
one wait for one block to go
through. And then we'll just get
the balance will say const. With
balance equals await I with that
balance of employer. So we're
going to call the balance of
function on our iWeb ERC 20
token. And then we'll just do
console dot log got West
balance.to string.
So we're using the main net
address in here. And we're gonna
say okay, we're going to deposit
some amount, we're going to
wait. And then we're gonna go
ahead and get the balance right,
so we're just depositing our
Aetherium so that we can get
that ERC 20 version of
Aetherium, that West token here.
Now, you might be thinking,
Okay, why are you putting the
main address in here? Let's
Patrick, slow down. Let's go
ahead and let's create a mock
Web Token contract address.
Let's deploy the mocks first,
and then we'll go ahead and use
that same setup that we've been
doing this whole time, why you
why you directly hard coding
this in here. Well, I've been
alluding to this for some time.
But there's another way that we
can run tests in our smart
contracts. And this is with
something called main net
forking, we can actually do
something where we fork the main
net, and run a local hard hat
node. That's pretending to be a
main net node. And all we have
to do is update our hard head
config to do so. So let's talk
about forking for a minute. So
on the left here, we have a
blockchain an example of
blockchain it's going to be
something similar to a test net
or main net like Rinkeby, eath,
main net polygon etc. This is
going to be a blockchain that we
deploy to. Now there are a whole
bunch of blocks in here, right?
We have this huge chain that we
can work with. And all this
information on the blockchain is
public information, like this
block is going to have
transaction transaction
transaction, each one of these
blocks is going to have a whole
bunch of transactions. And all
this information is on this
public blockchain. In addition
to all these transactions, it's
going to have things like price
feed contracts, it's going to
have things like Ave contract,
the Web token, contract, etc.
All this contract information is
public. So hypothetically, if
it's already there, we should be
basically able to copy this to
our local environment and do
some simulations ourselves. And
that's exactly what forking
does. A fork blockchain
literally takes a copy of an
existing blockchain like on the
left here and brings it on our
local computer. We actually have
control over our blockchain
that's running locally, because
it's gonna run on a local
computer, similar to hard hat.
Now, everything we do on this
local forked blockchain is not
going to affect main them,
because it's a simulated
blockchain. It's just running in
our local environment. So we can
actually interact with this
forking this kind of local
blockchain that resembles that
mimics the actual blockchain.
And here's what forking doesn't
do, it doesn't download the
entire blockchain into our local
setup. Anytime we reference an
address. Anytime we reference,
hey, there's something at a
specific address, we make an API
call to our Aetherium node,
which again, we're using alchemy
and say, hey, oh, what's at this
address, and it'll return just
that specific contract for us.
This way, we don't have to
download the whole blockchain.
And it's a lot quicker. And we
can also do this forking to run
our tests to run our scripts to
do everything. And now you might
be thinking, wow, Patrick, this
sounds awesome. Well, why don't
we just do this for everything?
Well, there's some trade offs.
The pros are that it's quick,
it's easy, and a test will
resemble what's on Main net. Now
the cons are that we need an
API, and we can't do everything
locally. Some contracts, some
contracts are complex to work
with, and mocks might just be
better. But using a forked
network might be a good way to
run your tests, it might be a
good alternate to just using
mocks. So it really depends on
what's right for you and right
for your project. But it is a
fantastic tool, especially for
something like Avi, where we
want to quickly test some
things. Now the hard forking
also will give us a bunch of
fake accounts. So we'll still
get a bunch of fake accounts on
Main net that will be given a
theorem. So we'll get fake main
net accounts for this forking.
So for the rest of this, we're
going to be using this forking
to run our scripts and run our
tests. If you want to go back
after this and try this all out
on COVID. We've got a whole
bunch of different addresses for
the COVID network so that you
can run these scripts directly
on COVID. And you can see the
transactions yourself. Just note
that when using COVID, you'll
want to make sure that you're
using the same addresses, as are
in the AVI docs for the COVID
network, because they do change
sometimes. Great, let's go
ahead, we'll go to our RT head
dot config dot j s. And now
we'll go to our networks, which
right now, I don't have
anything, I only have ranking.
And we'll add hard hat in here,
we'll add a little comma down
here. And we'll say, you know,
the chain ID of course is going
to be 31337. We'll add this
forking keyword. And in here,
we'll say the URL for a Forking
is going to be our main net RPC
URL. And this is another reason
why we're using alchemy. Alchemy
is fantastic at these forked
blockchains, and has really good
pieces here. So what we can do
is we can come back to our
alchemy dashboard, we'll create
a new app. This one will be for
Aetherium main net, and we'll
say forking chain. We'll say for
forking, we'll go ahead and
create this on a theory and main
net. Now that we have this
forking chain, we can do the
same thing. We'll grab our API
key, we'll come back to our
project, create this new file,
we'll create our dot env. And
we'll do main net RPC URL equals
and paste that in there. In our
Hardhead config, we are now
going to be forking from mainnet
RPC URL whenever we work with
the heart at blockchain. So now
that we have this in here, let's
go ahead and try to run this get
wet function. Because since
we're forking the blockchain, we
should be able to go ahead and
simulate this. So backing off a
borrow, we'll go ahead we'll do
const, get weath
equals require and then we'll
pull this script that dot dot
scripts slash get weath. And
then, in our main function,
we'll just run await yet. So to
run our script here, we'll do
yarn hard hat, run scripts
avevamo.js. And our default
network is hard hat. So we could
either do dash dash network hard
hat or just run it. And
remember, since in our config,
we're saying, hey, when we run
the hard hat chain, use this
forking, we're going to be
forking, so let's go ahead Run
this ran to air main. Net RPC
URL is undefined. Well, that
makes sense. Let's go ahead and
add this consummated RPC rel
equals process study and v dot
made it RPC URL. Let's try this
again. And we now see we got,
you know, this much weath,
which, again, that much wealth
is gonna be
1-234-567-8910 1234567 0.02
wealth, which is exactly what we
want. So now we have a way to
interact with main net locally,
which sounds kind of crazy. But
he's incredibly powerful for
exactly what we're doing right
here. So we have a way to fork
main that eath and run our
scripts and kind of test to see
and simulate what it would be
like to actually run these
transactions. So we're gonna do
like that, our get with function
looks good. And obviously, we
would still modularize this, we
put this in our helper Hardhead
config, but we're going to skip
doing that for now. So let's go
head back to the AVI borrow. And
let's go ahead and flesh the
rest of this out. Now, let's go
ahead and set up the rest of the
boilerplate here. So we'll do
const Deployer, because we need
an account, obviously equals
await, get named accounts. And
then we'll do const get named
accounts equals require. Now we
want to start interacting with
the ABI protocol, well, what do
we need, we're gonna need the
ABI and the address, nothing
changes, we're gonna need these
two. So what we can do is we can
go to the Ave docs. And again,
we're going to be on V two. And
we can go ahead and find the
contract address in here. Now
the way it works is they
actually have a contract, which
will point us to the correct
contract. The contract that
we're going to be doing all the
lending with is this lending
pool. And there's actually a
contract to get that contract
address. And to get the lending
pool address, we have to go to
the lending pool address
provider. It's this contract
that will tell us what the
address of the lending pullets.
And we can actually see the
deployed contract section, we
can see the address of this
contract. And we can see the
address of all the main ones and
the COVID. Once again, if you
want to play with this on COVID.
But we can see lending pool
address provider is going to be
located right here, we can copy
this address. And we'll just
take notes of this.
And that lending pool, we're
going to get from the lending
pelagics provider. So let's
actually create a function that
will get us the lending pool
address from the lending pool
address provider. So down here,
we'll create async function, get
lending pool. Now in order to
interact with this lending pool
address provider. Same thing,
we're going to need its address
and its API, we have its
address. So let's go ahead and
get its API, you can go ahead to
the GitHub repo associated with
this lesson. And just copy paste
it from the interfaces section.
You could also look directly on
the blockchain to see what this
contract looks I can create your
own interface. Or we can go
ahead and use the interface
right in the documentation. So
we have islanding Palach.
Provider, I'm just going to copy
this from the ABI docs. But
again, you've got a number of
options. And so in our contracts
in our interfaces, let's let's
stick iwth in interfaces here.
Let's create a new file. And
we'll call it I lending pool
address provider, dot soul. And
we'll paste it in here, we just
see we're using 0.6 point 12. So
be sure to in our Hardhead
config to make sure we have that
we don't so we're just create a
new one 0.6 point 12 And then
we'll compile yarn Hardhead
compile and compiles so awesome.
We now have the ABI here, we'll
get this contract by saying
const lending pool address
provider equals await ethers dot
get contract at will say I
lending pool address oops
address as I lending pool
addresses excuse me, I'm going
to update the name I Lenny pull
addresses provider islanding
pool addresses provider, we're
going to pass in that contract
address that we got from the
Ovid docs here. Paste that in.
And then we're going to connect
it to our Deployer. So we're
going to have our get lending
pool, get past that account
variable and then we'll just use
the account here to connect it
and the account that we're going
to pass is of course going to be
our Deployer. In our lending
pool address provider. There's a
function called Get lending pool
which returns the address of the
lining pool and this is going to
be the function that we're going
to call so we're gonna say const
lending pool address equals a
weight lending pool address says
probes address any pool address
says provider dot get lending
pool and that's it we'll have
the lending pool address and
then we'll have this contract
give us the lending pool
contract by doing const lending
pool equals await ethers dot get
contract Add. And we need to do
the same thing, the interface,
the interface, the address, and
then the account. So back in the
docs, we can grab the I lending
pool by copying this like this.
We'll go back to our contracts
interfaces, new file, I lending
pool, that's all. And we'll
paste it in. Now with this one,
if we scroll to the top, we
noticed that we're importing
from some local places that we
actually don't have in our
contracts area, we can once
again go ahead and add the AVI
protocol v2 from NPM. And just
use this as our imports. So
we'll do yarn, add dash dash dev
apt have a slash proto call
hyphen V two. And now that we
have the Add Ave protocol in our
node modules, we can update
these imports to point to our
node modules instead of our
local files. So I'm just gonna
go ahead and tell you that the
islanding pledge provider is
that Ave slash protocol hyphen V
to slash contracts slash
interfaces. And then data types
dot soul is gonna be at of a
protocol hyphen v2 slash
contracts slash, proto call
slash libraries, slash types,
data types, that's all again to
make sure this is right, yarn,
Hardhead compile or hh, compile.
And Cool. Looks like I did that
right? Lending pool equals await
ethers dot get contract at,
we're going to be using lending
pool, I lend the pool here,
we're going to use this lending
pool address got from the
addresses provider. And then the
account, which is going to be
our Deployer. And now we can do
return lending pool. And if we
want, and now that we have this
function get lending pool backup
in our main function, we can say
const lending pool equals a
weight, get lending pool and
then pass the Deployer. And then
we can even do a little console
dot log,
lending pool address and then do
lending pool dot address. And
since we're making it forking,
we can kind of just keep running
this right. So we'll do yarn
hardhat run scripts. Ave Baroda
Jas, there are multiple
artifacts for contract II
lending pool addresses provider.
And this is because in our node
modules, import all this stuff
from contracts and in here, and
there's already in islanding,
pool addresses provider in those
add ons slash contracts. So
actually, we don't even need
this, I lending pool added
service provider, we can go
ahead and delete it. Our time
right now is getting confused.
It's saying Oh, are you
referring to the one that you
downloaded from NPM or the one
that you made, which which one
do you want to use. So we'll
just make it easier for hardhat.
And we'll say okay, well, we'll
delete the one that we created,
we'll use the one that we've
downloaded here. And now we
should be good to run this
again. Because now there's only
one for to pick from, which is
the one we downloaded from NPM.
And perfect, we get our get
weath printout here, and then we
get lending pool address is
here. And this is going to be
the actual lending pool address
on ether Aetherium main net. So
if we go back to ether scan,
copy that address and paste it
and ether scan, we can see it's
even labeled Ave v two, and we
can see a ton of transactions
going through all the time. And
ether scan is having a hard time
keeping up with all the
transactions. So we've got the
lending pool address, we've got
some web token, what do we need
to do? Now we want a deposit of
what do we need in order to
deposit the token? Well, if we
look at the deposit function in
the avec GitHub, we can scroll
in here and we see it eventually
we'll call this safe transfer
from which is basically going to
be this transfer from function,
since we're calling transfer
from it's going to be this
contract, that's actually going
to pull the money out of our
wallet. So in order to give the
Ave contract, the ability to
pull the money out of our
wallet, we need to do what we're
going to need to approve the
contract. So first, before we
can even deposit we're gonna
need to approve it to get our
web token, we're gonna have to
get the Web Token first. So
let's get the Web Token address
we'll say const Web Token
address, equals and this is
where we marginalize it and get
it from our hard head helper
config. But for now, we can just
hard code it, the Web Token
contract address is going to be
the exact same thing as what's
in get web and then want to
approve. So let's write an
approved function because we're
going to use this a couple
times. So we'll make an async
function and approve ERC 20
And we'll take a contract
address a spender address, which
is going to be the contract that
we're going to give the approval
to to spend our token and amount
to spend so exactly how much we
want to prove it. And then an
account to do all this on. So in
here we'll say const ERC 20
token equals await ethers dot
get contract at. And we could
say I WEF but maybe we just want
like a simple ERC 20 token
interface. And we're going to
grab that by cheating a little
bit coin to our hard head defy
FCC. We're going to go to
interfaces and grab this
interface from here. So we're
going to copy this, paste it in
here New File IO ERC 20 dot som
paste and now we have an ABI for
ERC. 20s So we'll do get
contract that ERC 20 Actually
let's change this name to ERC.
20 address so we're going to get
the contract with the ABI of IRC
ERC 20 at contract address ERC
20 address and then we'll
connect it to our account here.
So and once we have the ERC 20
We can do const TX, we're going
to do that approve transaction
we'll do a weight ERC 20 token
dot approve spender address, and
then amount amount to spend.
We'll do we'll do a wait TX dot
wait for one block. And we'll do
a little console dot log saying
approved. Now if you don't run
this function before you try to
deposit you'll just get an error
saying hey, token is not
approved, which is a pretty
common error. So if you ever see
that just know, I forgot to
approve my token. So backup in
our main script, we'll go ahead
and run this function. We'll say
await approve ERC 20 with the
Web Token address lending pool
dot address because we want to
give the len pool the approval
to pull our web token from our
account. And then we'll give it
some amount to actually will
import a mount from get weath as
well. Mount we gotta go back to
get with an export it so we can
actually import it. So get with
exporting that amount that 0.02.
So we'll prove the amount and
then we'll connect we'll have
our Deployer do it obviously
because we're doing everything
with the Deployer. So we'll
approve the ERC 20. And then
once we approve, we can go ahead
and deposit it. So we'll say
console dot log, depositing
that. And then we'll run await
lending pool dot deposit. If we
look at the deposit function, we
can see all the parameters that
the deposit function takes. We
can also see it in the Ave v2
documentation and we just look
forward the posit. And we can
see it takes the address of the
asset that we're going to
deposit how much of that asset
we're going to deposit address
on behalf of we're going to do
it on behalf of ourself and then
a referral code, which right now
is just always going to be zero
because the referral code has
been discontinued. So we're
going to deposit the wet token
address, we're going to deposit
our web token, we're going to
posit 0.02 of that web token.
And then we're going to use a
deployer ash and then referral
code is going to be zero. And
then we'll do a little console
dot log the positive. So let's
try this script. Let's see if it
works. I'm just going to hit up
to go ahead and rerun this
script to rerun this command I
just ran into doing a little
compiling that ERC 20. That song
was compiled one solidity file,
got a bunch of wrapped Aetherium
lending pool address. We
approved it, we deposit we were
depositing it and then we
deposited it. So if we're
looking at our little readme
here, we get a little checkmark.
We've done step one, we've
deposited our collateral.
Awesome. So now we have some
collateral to use to borrow
other assets. Great. So now
we've deposited let's go ahead
and learn how to borrow now
through a couple of new lines,
and we'll say borrowed time. So
in order for us to borrow, we
probably want to know how much
we can borrow. And we want to
know more about our account,
right? We want to know how much
we have borrowed, how much we
have in collateral and how much
we can borrow. So there's a
function that Avi comes with
called Get User account data,
which will return the user's
account data across all
reserves, how much collateral we
have down the total value it in
its eath price, we have the
available borrows and eath
current liquidation threshold,
loan to value etc. Now these are
really important metrics. If we
have one, eath and collateral
that doesn't mean we can borrow
one eath of assets. Each one of
these tokens have some different
values like loan to value. For
example, if you have one eath
you can only borrow zero point
75 for the dye token, this is to
reduce risk of the collateral
and reduce risk of people not
having enough collateral down as
prices fluctuate. There's a
liquidation threshold of 80% if
you have one eath as collateral
and point 81 eath borrowed,
you'll get what's called
liquidated. So what is
liquidation? When you put down
collateral and you borrow, if
the amount that you have
borrowed past this liquidation
threshold is passed that 80% Or,
or depending on different
assets, it's different people
can do what's called liquidate
you. This is when they pay back
some of your loan that you took
out. And they also get to buy
some of your collateral at a
cheaper price. This keeps the
Ave platform solvent, and it
makes it so that there's never
more borrows than there are
collateral in order to borrow
assets, we still need that
collateral down. So basically,
if you borrowed more money than
you've put up, other users can
can take the money that you've
put up in return for them paying
for your loans. So we obviously
don't want this to happen. And
the audit protocol
programmatically doesn't want to
have not enough money to do
this. So they incentivize users
to liquidate, in case of these
failures is the protocols come
with this thing called a health
factor, which if this health
factor is below one, you go
ahead and you get liquidated,
the actual function to liquidate
somebody is called liquidation
call. So you can actually build
a bot and you can liquidate
users who go insolvent and you
can make a fee, you can make a
reward for actually doing this.
These protocols need to stay
solvent, they need to have
enough money to lend out. And
they programmatically enforced
this, which is why it's so
great. You can learn more about
liquidations in the liquidation
documentation. So this get us
account data will tell us how
much we have collateral, how
much we have in debt, and how
much we have available to borrow
based on how much collateral we
have. We can see the current
liquidation threshold we can see
the loan to value and then we
can see our health factor, which
is obviously really important.
If our health factor ever falls
below one, we get liquidated. So
we never want this hell factor
to fall below one when we're
borrowing assets. So let's
create a function that can grab
that first. So let's create a
new function called async.
Function get it borrow user
data, and we'll pass in the
lending pool contract, we'll
pass in the lending pool
contract and the account that we
want to get the data for. So we
can say const. And actually, we
can pull out just the values
that we want, we could pull out
the total collateral eath total
debt eath and the available to
borrow. Let's just pull out the
total collateral eath the total
debt if and the available,
borrows. So this equals await,
lending pool dot get user
account data of account. And now
we'll even just kind of logged
us out we'll say console dot log
you have total collateral eath
worth of eath the positive
console. Log you have total debt
eath worth of eath borrowed and
then console dot log you can
borrow
available borrows eath worth of
eath. And then we'll just return
available to borrow will turn
available borrows eath. And
we'll return or total debt, we
don't really need to return
total collateral we could if we
want we really just want to
print it out here. So now back
in our function, we can do in
our main function, we can run
let, I'm going to do that
because we're going to be
calling this a few times
available borrows eath. And
total debt eath
equals await, get borrow user
data of lending pool and
Deployer. And if we run this,
we'll see how much we can
actually borrow yarn hard hat or
just h h run scripts on a
borrowed.js and work on our
forked blockchain here. And
remember, it is going to be a
little bit slower. And this is
kind of one of the disadvantages
too because it does have to make
API calls whenever we want to
interact with these chains. And
then we got total collateral
eath is not defined. And that's
because I spelt total wrong. So
let's spell total correctly. And
we'll run this again. But okay,
great. So you have this month's
worth of eath deposited, you
have zero worth of eath borrowed
because we haven't borrowed
anything, and you can borrow
this much worth of eath.
Remember, the amount that we can
borrow is always going to be
less than the total amount that
we have as deposited. That's why
we see this lower number here.
So cool. So that's how much we
can borrow. Let's use that to go
and borrow some time. So we have
this total amount we can borrow
an eighth and we're gonna get to
borrow time. I promise we're
gonna get to borrow time, but we
need to figure out What's the
conversion rate of diets? We're
gonna get how much we can borrow
in eath. But we want to borrow
dye. So how much of dye can we
borrow based off of the value of
eath? And to do that, we're
gonna have to get the dye price.
And how are we going to do that?
Well, you guessed it, we're
going to use chain link price
feeds. If you look in the AVI
documentation, you can find
price Oracle, which is a
contract that you could actually
use right directly from Avi. But
the first thing it does is check
from a chain link aggregator,
which we already know how to do.
So we're gonna go ahead and just
call directly from the chain
link aggregator. So let's create
a new function function, we'll
call it get dye price is first
we're going to need to get that
interface, same thing. So you
can either go right to Hardhead
defy and just grab the interface
right from here, we could swap
this out with just an import
from chainlink NPM, as well. But
I'm just going to go ahead and
copy paste a new file, this is
going to be the Ag reg gate, Tor
v3 interface. Dot saw that we've
worked with so many times. Now
that we have this interface,
this will compile, we're
obviously looking for latest
round data, which will give us
this answer here, which is going
to be the price. So let's go
ahead and grab that. So we'll
say const di eath price feed
equals await ethers dot get
contract at and we'll use the
air, Greg a Tor v3 interface
will get the dye eath price feed
right from the chain link Docs.
So we go to docs dot chain dot
link UVM chains will go to
contract addresses on Aetherium.
Or look for di eath on Main net.
And we see di eath is right
here. So we'll grab this and
again, we're just hard coding it
in the GitHub repo associated
with it. With this, we put it in
a little config file, but we can
just go ahead and hard coded in.
And for this one, we don't need
to connect this to the deployer
account. Since we're not going
to be sending any transactions,
we're just going to be reading
from this contract, right. So
reading don't need a signer
sending me to signer. Now we can
say const price equals a weight
dye eath price feed dot latest
round data. Now latest round
data, as we know is going to
return us this huge thing. And
we only want the answer at the
first index. So another way we
could do this, we could just
wrap this whole thing up. And
then once this returns, we're
gonna say okay, just grab that
first index here, which will be
that price. And then we could do
a little console dot log, the dy
eath. Price is in price dot two,
like that, and then return
price. So we can go ahead and
run this as well test this out,
just by hitting up and then
enter. Depositing we deposited
this is how much we can deposit.
Nothing Oh, and I forgot to call
it oh, excuse me, let's go up.
This, let's say const dye price
equals await get dye price. And
tada. The dye youth price is
this big number, which of course
we know is going to be $3,289
which is which of course is
gonna be 3289 di per eath. Now
that we have the dye price, we
can figure out how much dye we
want to borrow. So great, we
have the price. Now let's figure
out the amount that we can
borrow in dye, we have the
amount we can borrow eath, we
need to convert it to die. So
we'll say const amount die to
borrow equals available, be the
available borrows in eath.to
string. And then in JavaScript,
we can do this.to string but
still do math. So times 0.95
times and then we'll do the
reciprocal of that die. So one
divided by die price.to number.
So this will give us the amount
of die that we can borrow. And
then we'll want to get this in
way. So if we print this out
right now, console dot log, you
can borrow.
Run this now, you can borrow
amount die to borrow. Not in way
units, which we need in way
units, but you can borrow 48
Die, which based off the price
looks about right. So to get the
correct units, we'll say const
amount, di to borrow way. That's
going to equal ethers dot utils
dot parse ether, MT di to
borrow.to string. This is just
purely the amount of dye to
borrow right so we get 48.79
die. But again, we want that in
way the die token has 18 decimal
places similar to Aetherium. So
we need that amount in way and
then we can go ahead and start
actually borrowing now. So we'll
create a new function called
borrow die async function,
borrow die will take the die
address. Take the lending pool,
take the amount die to borrow
and weigh in Then of course,
we'll take the account. And all
we'll do is we'll do const.
Borrow TX is going to be a
weight, lending pool dot borrow,
die address, amount die to
borrow. And again, we can go
right to the documentation, if
we want, it takes the address of
the asset, the amount, we want
to borrow the interest rate
mode, which is going to be
variable or stable, the referral
code and then address on behalf
of, we're going to say one for
the interest rate mode, where
one is going to be stable. And
then we're going to do zero or
this referral code because
that's debunked now, and then
we'll do a count, then we'll do
a wait, borrow TX dot Wait, wait
one transaction, and then we'll
do console dot log you've
borrowed. Well, and that's it.
So we now have this borrowed I
function. So back up in our main
function, right, now, we can
finally do the borrow time. So
we'll do a wait, borrow die. And
we'll pass those parameters in
here. So we're going to do
const, die token address, equals
and we're just going to hard
code this from main net. So we
can look up die token address,
main net, we'll grab this
address here, this looks like
this is indeed the DI token, we
check right on the object get
up, we could check right on the
ABI of actual code, since we're
just testing, we're just gonna
go ahead and grab from ether
scan here. So for borrow dye,
we're gonna need the dye token
address, we're gonna need the
lending pool contract the amount
of dye to borrow in way, and
then our Deployer. And then
we'll await borrow dye. And then
we will run this get bar user
data again, just print out the
information about where we are
after we do that. So when we can
run this, again, we should see
the amount that we have
borrowed, updated, our first
call to that function is gonna
say, Hey, you have this much eat
the positive Do you have nothing
borrowed, you can borrow this
much eath, we get the price, we
get how much we borrowed, we
borrow. And now it says you have
this much where the eath
deposited and you have this much
worth of eath borrowed and you
can borrow this much eat. So we
actually now have bought a bunch
of this dye actually borrowed.
And the reason we're doing times
zero point 95, we don't want to
hit that cap of the maximum
amount that we can borrow. So
we're saying hey, let's get 95%
of the amount that we actually
can borrow. So we're not going
to borrow everything, we're just
gonna borrow 95%. And you can
see that the amount of eath we
have deposited is actually
higher. This is because we're
actually gaining interest just
by having this eath deposited.
And now that we have some dye
borrowed, we borrowed 48 dye,
which is equivalent to this much
Aetherium. And then we still
have a little bit more we can
borrow because we only borrowed
95%, which is great.
Awesome, we've taken out a
borrow programmatically, let's
repay at least some of it here.
So we're gonna have to create a
new function that's going to use
the repay function in the
contract. So we're gonna do
async function repay, and this
is going to take the amount that
we want to repay the dye address
that we're going to repay the
lending pool and then the
account now to repay once again,
we're going to have to approve
sending our dye back to Ave So
in here, the first thing we need
to do is we actually need to
call wait prove ERC 20 with the
dye address, lending pool dot
address, mount and then
accounts, right because approve
ERC 20. That's the input
parameters it takes, and we need
to approve sending the dye back
to the contract. So we borrowed
it, and we're gonna send it
back. Now we're actually going
to send it back. So let's say
const, repay TX equals await,
lending, cool that repay the
address, amount, one account.
And then we'll say await repay
TX dot Wait, that will do
console dot log repaid up in our
main function, we're going to do
a weight repay, and we're going
to give it the amount dye to
borrow in way. We're gonna give
it the dye token address, give
it lending pool, and then we'll
give it deployer get you borrow
user data one more time just so
we can print out the final
amounts. Now, you'll notice
something though, we're going to
give back all of the dye that we
borrowed. However, we're still
going to have a dye balance,
you'll see that when I run this
that we're still have a little
bit of Aetherium borrowed,
basically, we'll still have a
dye balance because we'll still
have a little bit of die borrow
and try to figure out why before
I answer it actually. So we have
this tiny, tiny tiny amount of
eath borrowed here and we have a
much larger amount of eath
deposited so Why do we still
have this tiny, tiny amount of
eath borrowed? Well, the reason
is because as we borrow dye, we
actually accrued interest. So we
still owe dye back. Now what we
can do is we can do something
like uniswap, to actually swap
our Aetherium, for dye to repay
the rest of our debt here. And
that's how we could actually
finish repaying all the debt is
to get a little bit more dye to
pay off that interest that we
had accrued. And if you want,
you can go back and you can do
the exact same thing we did here
to grab the uniswap code, place
it in here to programmatically
repay your debt as well. But at
this point, you have just gone
through the entire lifecycle
here. And that is absolutely
massive, huge congratulations.
You've just deposited borrowed
and repaid tokens from the AVI
protocol. Now I'm going to go
briefly show you what some of
these transactions are going to
look like on an actual test net,
on an ether scan, you'll see
that when we deposit our
collateral, we actually get back
what's called an A token, or an
interest bearing token, these
tokens keep track of how much
collateral or in our case how
much web token we have deposited
in the AVI protocol. And when we
want to withdraw our wealth
back, we burn these eight
tokens, we remove these eight
tokens, you can see that our
first transaction is going to be
deposit and I wanted to show you
what it looks like when you
actually deposit one of these
tokens, this transaction
associated with this lending
pool, that deposit right here,
if you look at tokens transfer
down here, you can see we
actually we deposited, you can
see that we actually sent rapt
ether to the ARB a contract. Now
you'll also see this a weath
stuff here. So what is this a
with stuff. So to keep track of
how much you've actually
deposited into Ave, Ave will
give you your own a wealth token
or a token to keep track. And
this is this interest bearing
token, you actually can see up
here a little bit of interest
already for actually depositing
these tokens into the protocol.
And it's this token, that will
keep going up, the more people
borrow and the more people use
the protocol. So you can
actually grab this token
address, interest bearing token
this a token, I can import it
into my meta mask. And I can see
that I have 0.1, which
represents my initial deposit
00517 dot that dot A with and if
you keep this up long enough,
this number will slowly go up as
you get more and more. Because
the interest keep out and you
can see just went went up right
there, the interest will keep
changing and keep going up.
Obviously, we have so little
deposited that the interest
isn't gonna go up very quickly,
but it will go up, the more
people use the protocol. And
since I'm using a test net, the
actual usage of the protocol
isn't very high, but you get the
picture.
Awesome, you've done phenomenal
to get this far. Let's do a
quick recap of everything that
we've learned. And then we'll
head on to the next section. So
first, we learned about the web
token or the wrapped Aetherium
token, it's a way to tokenize
our Aetherium or layer one
blockchain native token. Then we
learned a little bit about the
AVI protocol, and how it's this
defy primitive for borrowing and
lending assets. And we can
actually gain interest by
depositing our tokens and our
assets into Ave we learned a
little bit of also about
uniswap, which is another
incredibly important defy
protocol, which allows us to
swap tokens between each other
in the decentralized context,
then we learned that we can
actually deposit some of our
tokens into the AVI protocol,
which is a decentralized
borrowing and lending platform
and similar to a bank will
actually gain interest on our
deposited tokens. But first, we
have to approve them. Because
anytime you want a contract to
interact with your tokens, you
need to approve the contract to
do so. And then we go ahead and
deposit once we deposited we got
the dye price. And then we
learned that we can actually
borrow dye we can borrow an
asset based off of how much
collateral we put down. And then
we learned how to repay it back.
We learned about forking a
blockchain as opposed to using
our own main blockchain. Another
thing to know if you are using
an RPC URL like something from
alchemy so awesome you've
learned a ton about defy now
defi is an absolutely massive
powerhouse when it comes to the
blockchain. And it is one of the
most important things
blockchains can do. If you want
to learn more about defy and
read more on Defy. I've got some
more links in the GitHub here so
that you can learn more about
defy and one of them in
particular that I want to show
you is this one called speed run
Etherium. Not only does it give
you a ton of defy examples, but
it gives you a whole bunch of
other examples as well. And this
will be a good test of
everything that you've learned
after you pass this course. Or
even right now if you want to or
whenever you want and to talk
about it a little bit more, we
actually have Austin Griffiths
here to talk a little bit more
about speed run Aetherium
himself, I'll pass it over to
Austin.
Hey, what's up, I'm Austin
Griffith, I want to show you
speed run Aetherium. speed run
Aetherium is a great way to get
started in Aetherium. If you are
a developer, it's targeted at
web two developers becoming web
three developers speed run a
theory. m.com is the website. It
takes you through both getting
started and kind of getting
getting an idea for the language
and the syntax. But that's just
the start. Just understanding
the language is just the start,
you feel like you're you can do
anything. And you're on the top
of the world when you finally
get the syntax of solidity
together, and you can jam
through a smart contract. But
really getting context with the
space and figuring out what
works and what doesn't, that's a
whole nother battle. And that's
where speed run aetherium.com
comes in. So let's speed run the
speed run. First, you will get
scaffold e down speedrun
Aetherium kind of revolves
around scaffold eath and uses
scaffold eath as a base, you'll
want to tinker around with some
ideas within solidity. And let
me show you what I mean by that.
So with scaffold eath, you have
a front end and you have your
smart contract. So scaffold eath
comes with hard hat out of the
box. And you will use the
combination of hard hat and
react to build a DAP where
you'll deploy both the smart
contract and the front end. And
this, this ability to edit your
smart contract and have your
front end auto adapt to it is
kind of the key to scaffold
ease. I just added some extra
extra exclamation points. But
we'll see that show up over
here. Once this contract
deploys, there we go, there's
that. So just real quick, again,
if I create like a un 256 public
counter, and we set that equal
to five, and then I build a
function called increment,
that's public that does counter
public, there we go, that does
counter plus, plus, you can
imagine what's going to happen
here. So you, you edit a little
bit of solidity, you deploy your
contract, and then your front
end auto adjust to that. And it
gives you the ability as a
developer to call those
functions tinker with your smart
contract to play around, you can
even have a console log in
there, where it you know, sets
says the count now is there we
go something like this. And
let's go ahead and deploy that.
Notice I'm doing these quick
iterations, I'm making small
changes in solidity, and I'm
seeing those changes show up in
the front end. And I'm tinkering
with those in the front end and
testing my assumptions. Here, if
we go look at our hard hat node,
when I make this increment call,
we should see that nice console
log there, you know, this
address, set the count to eight,
right? Very, very cool. So this
is scaffold eath. This is what
speed run Aetherium is built on
top of, you'll get in here,
you'll edit your smart contract,
then you'll edit your front end,
you'll point your front end at
some particular network, you'll
deploy your smart contract,
you'll deploy your app, it just
gives you the ability to have a
front end along with your smart
contract. And you'll have that
as you're building your smart,
smart contract. So to have this
front end, to tinker with your
smart contract is going to help
you kind of figure out how you
want to write your solidity,
like, is this going to be a
mapping? Is this going to be an
array? How am I going to track
this struct, you can kind of do
this in an iterative process by
just throwing it in here into
your smart contract and
tinkering with it on the front
end and trying it out and seeing
what you need to build. So
that's scaffold eath. And that's
the base that you'll need to get
started with speed run Ethereum.
Once you've you're able to have
this all installed, you'll
you'll have your kind of react
front end here with yarn start,
you'll have yarn chain, which
will run your your hard hat
node, then you'll do yarn
deploy. Once you have that setup
locally, you're ready to go with
speed run Aetherium. And you can
also do this right here and
challenge zero. So challenge
zero, gotta go zero index,
right, we got to be nerdy
challenge zero sets you up with
just getting the environment
setup, you'll you'll quest on
building a simple NFT example.
It's going to come with an NFT
smart contract. And it's going
to come with an NFT front end a
little kind of like minting
view, it'll come with all of
this stuff to do that. And it'll
walk you through basically
challenge the row is going to
hold your hand, it's going to
take you through every step
you'll have to get get you have
to have a certain version of
node E, L some some correct
range of node and yarn
installed. Watch out yarn has an
executable on Linux, make sure
you have the yarn, the package
manager. But after you have get
your node and yarn, you'll run
through cloning down each
challenge. You'll do an install,
you'll fire up the chain and
you'll fire up your front end.
And you'll have a working app
that lets you interface with
your NFT smart contract. You'll
go through here and you'll learn
about wallets. Then you'll start
minting NF Ts and you'll send
those NF T's are Round. And
that's challenge zero, it's just
getting you started. Here even
in challenge zero, you'll deploy
this NFT to Rinkeby. And you'll
also deploy an app and allow
your friends to go to your app
and mint in FTS on Rinkeby. So
that's the first challenge, it
looks like we even like dive
into open see and play around
with some of those mechanics.
The second challenge challenge
number one challenge one of
speed runner theory is like
where it all really starts. This
really shows off the superpower
of Aetherium. It sets it up. So
you need to build an app where a
bunch of people that don't
necessarily trust each other,
can coordinate and stake into a
smart contract. And this is
like, this is the superpower of
Aetherium. The ability for you,
the developer to write a few
simple rules to allow jerks to
coordinate financially, and not
greet each other and steal each
other's money, right? You're
we're building these financial
systems, there's, you know, game
theory and economics and so many
other things going on here. But
you as the developer, you're
writing simple rules, and you're
building a system that allows
people to coordinate. So
challenge one, we'll take you
through how to get set up with
your steak or docile, smart
contract, you'll install
everything exactly the same way,
you'll fire everything up. And
then it's just going to walk you
through the kinds of things that
you will need in your smart
contract. But you'll have to
write the solidity yourself. So
this is this is not going to be
a handheld tutorial, hell thing,
you're going to have to write
the smart contract yourself. And
there's some guidelines and some
rails that kind of help you out,
but it's not going to do it for
you. Okay, so that's, that's
Quest One is or that's
challenge. One is building a
decentralized staking app. Then
challenge two is building a
token vendor this so in
challenge one, you'll learn
things like how to send money
into a contract, how to have a
contract, keep track of
mappings. In challenge two,
you're going to learn contract
to contract interaction, you're
going to learn about ERC 20s,
you're going to learn about
specifically the approved
pattern, which is kind of a
jerk, it's, it's hard, it's a
hard thing to deal with is the
approved pattern, you need to go
to your token contract and
approve the vendor to take some
money, then in a second
transaction, you need to go to
the vendor and have the vendor
grab the money from the token
contract and do something else.
So that's that's challenge two
is learning about tokens and
vendors, and is starting to
really like get you kind of
exposed to the idea of this like
massive multiplayer game that is
Aetherium. And also kind of like
how to build these vending
machines that anybody can get
to, then you'll build a Dex. Now
once you've once you're done
with 01. And two, you're really
kind of you have a license to
learn at this point, you're
you're ready to really like go
do some damage and build some
cool things, maybe go build a
couple other things, but come
back and come come hit challenge
three, challenge three is going
to be a little bit more open
ended, there's going to be a
cohort of other people that are
also building this. And you have
to get through the first three
challenges to even get to
challenge three to even get to
this chat room. But there's a
chat room where other developers
that are also building their own
decks are all there together,
and you can kind of learn with
them and chat with them. But
you're going to build an
exchange. And you're going to
build an exchange that works in
a smart contract in a
decentralized way with no
centralized breaking points. And
what that's going to mean is
you're going to have to have
reserves of both eath and tokens
and you're gonna have to have a
pricing function and LP tokens
and all sorts of other things
that you'll have to learn about
as you get to it. Then challenge
five is a multi SIG wallet. Such
a fundamental important thing
about how to store your eath
safely is going to be in a multi
SIG wallet and how you can have
multiple identities even even
like the the base of like what a
Dow is, is sort of like starting
with a multi SIG wallet. And
you'll need to build one of
those you'll need to understand
call data call data is super
weird and complex. And
everything's a transaction even
when you're just poking a
contract. It's a transaction,
and you have to craft that call
data correctly to say, I would
like to call this specific
function on this specific
contract. So that's multisig
wallets and then it kind of ends
up we've got more challenges in
the pipeline, but it kind of
ends on build an SVG NFT so much
fun to build an NF t that crafts
the actual drawing in the smart
contract and renders it. So
that's the speed run, go speed
run Aetherium checkout scaffold,
eat start building, build
something awesome on Aetherium.
hearts, hearts, hearts, go get
them.
Austin Griffith is one of the
OGS when it comes to helping
engineers get caught up and up
to speed in the blockchain world
so massive thank you to Austin
for all he's done so far.
All right now we're gonna get
into NF T's. Let's do this. Now,
I've already made a number of
videos on what NF T's are and
how to start working with NF
T's. So we're going to watch a
portion of the previous Python
edition of this course where I
explain and a piece from a high
level and then of course, we're
gonna get into the ultimate NFT
tutorial. So let's learn about
NF T's look, NF T's are hot
right now. Nf T's also known as
ERC 720 ones are a token
standard that was created on the
Ethereum platform. Nf T stands
for non fungible token is a
token standard similar to the
ERC 20. Again, ERC 20 is like
link of a maker, all those
goodies that are found on the
Etherium chain. An NF T or a non
fungible token is a token that
is non fungible, this means that
they are starkly unique from
each other. And one token isn't
interchangeable with any other
token of its class. A good way
to think about it is $1 is
interchangeable with any other
dollar $1 is going to have the
same value of another dollar.
Those are fungible tokens that's
like ERC 20s one link is always
going to be equivalent to one
other link, by contrast is going
to be NF T's those of you nerds
out there, we know like a
Pokemon would be a good example
of an NFT you're one Pokemon is
going to have different stats,
different moves, sets, and isn't
interchangeable with any other
Pokemon, or maybe a more
relatable one. It's like a
trading card, or unique piece of
art or the like. So that's what
these NF T's are there non
fungible, non interchangeable
tokens that for the moment are
best represented or thought
about as digital pieces of art
that are incorruptible and have
a permanent history of whose own
them who's deployed them, etc.
Now, like I said, NF T's are
just a token standard. So you
can actually make them do much
more than just be art. You can
give them stats, you can make
them battle, you can do really
unique things with them, you can
do pretty much whatever you want
with them. But right now, the
easiest way to think about it,
and the most popular way to
think about it is by calling
them ah, ah, ah it's odd, or
some type of collectible or just
anything that's unique. Now,
they've been getting a ton of
buzz recently, because we've
been seeing more and more of
these being sold at insane
prices, like we saw x infinity
sell nine plots of their land
nine plots of their unique land
for $1.5 million. We also saw
the original creator of the Nyan
Cat, you know, this cat
sold for like 300 eath. So
apparently people really value
these things. So like I said,
they're just tokens that are
deployed on a smart contract
platform, and you can view them
on different NFT platforms like
open sea or wearable. And these
are the NFT marketplaces that
let people buy and sell them.
You obviously can do that
without these marketplaces,
because it's a decentralized but
they're helping give a good user
interface. Now, like many of you
out there, my initial thought to
NF T's was okay, this sounds
pretty dumb. But I think that
that was dumb. I think art does
have a lot of value. And I think
that artists are not always paid
fairly for what they do. And
this is actually a huge issue
right now in the modern day
world where an artist can make
some type of art people just
copy paste it, you know,
everywhere and, and they never
get attribution for what they
make. So having a really easy
decentralized royalty mechanism,
or some type of mechanism where
these artists can get accurately
comped for what they're doing, I
think, is really important. I
love music. I love movies, those
are pieces of art that I digest.
And I really like and I think
it's fair for them to get comped
appropriately because they are
providing value to my life. I
think NF T's are a great way to
solve this issue as kind of
having these decentralized audit
trails and, and royalty trails
that we can set up and, and see
really transparently without
having to go through some
centralized service. So that's
the basic gist of it. Let's talk
some more about the standards
ERC 721 standard are the NFT
standard. This is the basis of
it all there is another standard
that's semi fungible tokens, the
1155 We're not going to talk
about that here. But you can
check it out the main
differences between a 721 and
the ERC 20 and ERC. 20 is they
have a really simple mapping
between an address and how much
that address holds. 720 ones
have unique token IDs, each
token ID has a unique owner. And
in addition, they have what's
called a token URI, which we'll
talk about in a minute. Each
token is unique. Each token ID
represents a unique asset. So
since these assets are unique,
and we want to be able to
visualize them and show what
they actually look like we need
to define those attributes of
the object. If it's a piece of
art, we needed a way to define
what that art looks like. If
it's some type of character in a
game, we need to wait define
that character stats in the NFT.
This is where metadata and token
URI has come in. So if you know
anything about Aetherium, you
know that sometimes gas prices
getting pretty high, especially
when it comes to storing a lot
of space, it can get really,
really expensive. So one of your
first questions might be Well,
are they storing these images?
And these are pieces on chain?
And the answer is sometimes back
when they were coming up with NF
T's and artists were deploying
stuff, the eath devs and the
artists were like yeah, art,
let's do that art. I'm just
gonna deploy This one megabyte
image onto the Etherium chain.
And Oh god, it's so much gas
expensive, delete button.
Otherwise, it's not, it's not
good. And they realized that if
they put all this art on chain,
it's going to be incredibly
expensive. So to get around
this, what they did is they put
in the standard, what's called
the token URI. This is a
universally unique indicator of
what that asset or what that
token looks like and what the
attributes of the token are, you
can use something like a
centralized API, or IPFS. To
actually get that token URI.
Typical token URI has to return
something in this format like
this, where it has the name, the
image, location, the
description, and then any
attributes below, there is often
this talk of on chain metadata
versus off chain metadata.
Because it is so much easier and
cheaper to store all your
metadata off chain, a lot of
people will use something like
IPFS that is decentralized, but
does take a little bit of
centrality to keep persisting,
but they can also use their own
centralized API. However,
obviously, if that goes down,
then you lose your image, you
lose everything associated with
your NFT. Because of this most
NFT marketplaces actually can't
and won't read off on chain
attributes or on chain metadata,
because they're so used to
looking for the token URI.
Obviously, if you do off chain
metadata, you can't do anything
really cool or really
interesting or have any gains
with your NF T's. For example,
if you wanted to create an on
chain Pokemon game, all your
attributes would need to be on
chain in order for your Pokemon
to interact with each other.
Because if it was off chain,
then that becomes a lot harder
to cryptographically prove. So
if you're new with NF T's and
you're like wait, this is kind
of a lot of information, I'll
make it easy for you. If you're
looking to render an image, I'm
an NFT, add your image to IPFS,
add a metadata file pointing to
that image file on IPFS. And
then grab that token URI and put
it and set it as your NFT. The
chain link DND article does a
great job of walking you through
this and showing you how to do
this. So be sure to read that if
you're looking to learn how to
do that we're not going to cover
that in this video, but we will
be deploying our first NFT with
some on chain attributes. Again,
having your attributes on chain
is really going to allow you to
build really creative NF T's
that build games or have
interesting properties and and
really makes the authenticity of
your NFT guaranteed because
those attributes are always
going to be on chain.
Alright, so now that we know the
basics of approximately what an
NF t is, and similar to the ERC
20 You can see the E IP 721 or
the ERC 721 non fungible token
standard on the Aetherium, ie
IPs. And once again, if you
scroll down, you can see all the
different events and the
different functions that come
with creating this token. And
now everything that we're going
to do is going to be available
at this GitHub repo. This hard
hat NFT FCC, we're going to
actually go through all the code
down to deploying and creating
our own customized NFT. And I've
labeled this the ultimate NFT
repo as part of this course,
because we're going to go
through a lot here, we're gonna
go through a basic NFT, a real
minimalistic NFT and then an
IPFS hosted NFT. That is
dynamic. And it uses randomness
to generate unique NF T's so
that we can have provably rare
and appease or provably rare
cards or provably rare tokens or
stats or whatever you want. And
then we're going to do what's
called an SVG NFT. These are
entities that are 100 percent hosted on
chain, so you don't need an off
chain. So you don't need IPFS,
you don't need an off chain
database. And this one's also
going to be dynamic, where it's
going to use price feeds in
order to fluctuate what the
image of the entity actually
looks like based off the price
of some asset. And here are the
images that we're going to be
using. And we obviously have
these three adorable doggies
here. If you want to follow
along with the Quickstart, you
absolutely can. And I'm going to
do a quick overview of just
running the code to show you
what it's going to look like at
the end. Basically, what we're
going to do is we're going to
have our code, we're going to
run hardhat deploy dash dash
network, rink B, dash dash tags
main. And this is going to
deploy all of our contracts and
everything. And then finally, if
we go to test nets dot open c.io
And we grab the address of one
of these NF T's we should be
able to put it in here see our
actual NFT as a collection with
an item. Or Additionally, we can
just go right to the contract.
We can read the contract, we can
get the token URI, and then we
can copy this token here, I
paste it into our browser or any
IPFS is into our browser, and
then grab the image attribute
and see what this actually looks
like on chain. So with all that
being said, let's learn how to
build this ultimate NFT repo and
build all of these different
customizable NF T's let's jump
in. So once again, we're in our
terminal I'm going to create a
new directory. We're gonna call
it hard hat and a T for FCC.
We're gonna cd into that. And if
T FCC and we're going to open
that up with code.or, you can
hit File, Open Folder At this
point, you'll have gotten pretty
familiar with the setup of our
code bases here, feel free to
copy over or do whatever you
want to do for our setup, we'll
do yarn, add dash dash dev hard
hat. And then while that's
loading, I'm going to copy over
my prettier files. Because I
want to use prettier, I'm going
to copy over my hard
hat.config.js. And I'm also
going to grab my package that
Jason copied over here, I'm
going to delete this old package
dot JSON. And I'm just going to
hit Enter on this and rename the
one I just copied over from
package copy to package json.
And the reason I'm doing this is
so that I can just go ahead and
run yarn and install all this
stuff for me. Or we can just
come back over here and just
grab this lesson nine hard hat,
smart contract lottery, all that
stuff, again, just run that
massive piece as well. Or you
can copy over your package json,
and then just run yarn that will
do the same thing. Now we don't
have to keep doing this
boilerplate over and over and
over again. And then while
that's loading, I'm also going
to grab my Dotty and v file that
we've been using on a past
couple of projects, the
readme.md. And we'll just do
what we're gonna be doing here.
So we're going to make three
different contracts. One is
going to be a basic NFT, using
that ERC 721 standard, then
we're gonna do a random IPFS
hosted NF t. And then finally,
we're going to do a dynamic S V
G NFT. So our random NF T is
going to be random at creation
time, this is going to give some
true scarcity and some true
randomness to our NF T. And it's
gonna be hosted on IPFS. Our
dynamic SVG NFT is going to be
hosted 100 percent on chain, and the
image of it's going to change
based off of some parameters.
That's what makes it a dynamic
SVG NFT.
Let's go ahead and we'll create
a new folder, we'll create our
contracts folder, and we will
create our first NF t this is
going to be our basic NFT. And
I'm going to go a little bit
quick here, because most of what
we're going to be doing is
actually things that we're
already familiar with. So we'll
do basic NF T dot soul in a new
file. And let's go ahead and
let's do it. Let's go ahead and
we'll do spdx license
identifier, it's gonna be MIT.
We'll do pragma, solidity,
carrot zero, point 8.7 pragma,
solidity, and then we'll do
contract, basic NF t. Let me
just basic, get a t.so, like
that. And we'll say contract
basic NF t. And then we'll just
run hard at compile or yarn
hard, hit compile, and it looks
like we're doing well here so
far. Okay, perfect. Based off of
that NFT token standard, we go
back that EIP, we're going to
need a whole bunch of different
functions here, we're going to
need transfer events, we're
going to need owner events
bounce up, we're going to all
these different functions. And
we could 100 percent implement these
and transfer them exactly like
the ERC 20 did, or once again,
so we can use, you guessed it,
we're gonna be using open
Zeppelin contracts for this as
well. So we come back over to
open Zeppelin, we go over to
contracts. And we're gonna go
ahead and add this with yarn,
add dash dash Dev. So yarn, add
dash dash dev at opens up on
contracts, like so. And while
that's going through, we can
look at the ERC 721 of this and
we can see what creating a
minimalist ERC 721 looks like.
Now there's a number of
extensions that come with its
ERC. 721 In this example that
they give us. They're using ERC
721 Uri storage, which we'll
talk about in a little bit. So
we've added it in here. And now
we can actually import that ERC
21 from opens up when in our
contract. So we'll do import at
open Zeppelin slash contracts
slash token slash your C 721
slash ERC. 721 does so they use
a different one in the demo, but
don't worry about that. And same
as the ERC. 20 we're gonna say
our basic NFT is ERC 721. So
we're doing this inheritance,
you find the constructor, we can
see this has a constructor,
where it takes a name and a
symbol. So we're gonna want to
use this constructor and our
contract. So we're gonna say,
construct door.
And our constructor is just
going to be blank. But we'll do
the ERC 721 constructor and
we'll call this a doggie. And
the symbol will be dog just like
that. Our basic NFT we're just
going to have it be this doggy
here, right so it's going to be
an NF T of just a purely this
dog here. The name is going to
be doggy and the symbol is going
to be dog. Now in order to
create new dogs. What we're
going to do is openzeppelin code
comes with something called a
mint function exactly the same
as the ERC 20 So we're going to
create a function called mint
NFT this will be a public file
function that's going to return
you activity six. And we'll use
the safe mint function of this
ERC 20 or underscore safe mint
message dot sender will mint the
token to whoever calls this mint
function. And then we need to
also give this a token ID, if
we're looking back at the code
for the ERC 721. And again, you
can see this on GitHub as well,
we're gonna look at this safe
mint function, it takes an
address to who is going to own
the NFT. And then a token ID,
what is the ID of the token
based off of this address. So if
you have a collection of tokens
on the same smart contract, each
one of them needs their own
unique token ID. So what we're
gonna do is we're gonna create a
un 256, private variable called
S underscore token counter, and
it's gonna get initialized in
our constructor to zero, but
we'll just be explicit and say
es token counter equals zero.
And then in here, we'll just
have the token ID of this new NF
t be that token counter. And
then of course, we'll say s
token counter equals s token
counter plus one. So every time
we meant a new NFT, we up the
token counter, and then we'll
just return, we'll just return
the new tab counter. Right. And
then obviously, at the bottom,
we could do like function, get
token counter, this would be a
public view returns you in 256.
And I'm gonna go a little quick
here, because you've seen this
before, return s underscore
token counter, right, since it's
a private variable up here, the
public function down here to get
that token counter. So this
technically, is it. This is
technically an NF T. But what
does this look like? Well, right
now, this NF T isn't going to
look like anything at all, in
this EIP token standard. It has
this thing called a token URI.
And this is the important
function that tells us exactly
what this token is going to look
like. Like what we said in the
mini lesson here. This token URI
returns some type of URL or
universal resource identifier
that returns some JSON that
looks like this. And in this
JSON, we're going to have this
image part. And this image is
going to be a URL that's going
to point to what this image
actually looks like. Now this
URL can be hosted on chain, it
can be hosted on IPFS, it can be
hosted really wherever. But
ideally, we're not going to use
a centralized server to host it.
If this is hosted on a Google
Cloud or a centralized server or
whatever, and our centralized
server goes down. Well guess
what this MC is gonna look like,
it's not gonna look like
anything. So we want to use some
type of decentralized storage,
to get a URL, or URI to store
what this looks like. To make
this section a little bit easier
for you, I've actually already
gone ahead and hosted an image
to IPFS. For you, it's going to
be at IPFS dot dot slash slash,
it's going to look like this,
this is going to be the image
that we're going to use for our
dog here. If you create just
this image, though, as the token
URI, that's not going to work,
we need a URI that returns this,
with the image inside of it. Now
for this first section, have
already gone ahead and done that
for you as well. And that's
going to be located here. This
is what our token URI function
needs to return. So it's going
to have the name, the
description, the image URI,
which then points to the dog,
and then some attributes, etc,
etc. Now, you'll notice that the
image here is pointing to HTTPS,
dot dot slash slash ipfs.io. The
reason I did this was again,
just in case you didn't have the
IPFS gateway, but this would be
a lot better if this was in its
IPFS form. Because if the
centralized server ipfs.io, goes
ever goes down, this NFT will
show what it'll show nothing. So
it would be much better. If it
was instead of ipfs.io. It was
IPFS, colon slash slash, like
that, instead of ipfs.io. But
for now, this is what we're
going to be using. And you can
just go to the GitHub for this,
just to grab this for this
section. Right? Just go to
contracts, basic NFT, you can
just grab this, this, this top
part, just copy it like that. So
we're going to paste that the
token URI up, up, up at the top,
like so. Oh, it should be
returns, return. There we go.
Okay, cool. So we're just going
to copy paste that in here like
this. Like I said, even though
the token URI here is pointing
directly to IPFS, which is good.
If you actually go to this file,
the file is actually pointing to
http.ipfs.io. Again, for your NF
T's don't do that for this NFT.
I just did that just in case,
but for your NF T's don't do
that. And we're going to make
this a public constant variable.
Why? Well, because this token
you write is never going to
change. We're going to make this
NFT so that everybody who meets
one will have this exact same
adorable little puck here. And
the way we do That now is we
need to identify the actual
token URI function. So I'm going
to do it above get token
counter, we're going to say
function, token URI. And these
always take a UNT 256 token ID,
we're going to make this a
public view, override returns
string memory. And this needs to
return the token URI. Now, this
is going to be the most basic
way to create this, right. And
if we wanted to make this
function a little nicer, we'd
comment out token ID as well,
since we're actually not using
token ID. But we're overriding
in our in the ERC 721 that we're
importing. This has a token ID
function or a token URI
function. And we're overriding
this, right, we're not using
this at all, we're saying, Hey,
we're just going to use our own
here. And that's all we need for
this to work. And now if you
were to deploy this to rink B,
if you were to jump over to open
C test net, and you would deploy
this, this dog, this adorable
little pop would be what shows
up for all the minutes. So let's
go ahead, and let's create a
little deploy function for this.
So we'll do a new folder, deploy
a new file, we'll call this a
one deploy basic NF T dot j s.
And this is going to look real
similar to everything that we've
done before. So I'm going to
move a little bit quicker here.
const network equals require
hard hats, const development
chains, equals require dot dot
slash helper, hard hats config.
And I don't think I added that.
So I'm going to copy paste my
helper Hardhead config from our
last project. And if you get
confused, you can always just
come to the GitHub here, and
just go to the helper Hardhead
config and grab it from here, we
have that const development
chains, or say const verify
equals require dot dot slash
utils. Slash verify. We're also
going to grab our utils, I'm
going to copy paste so utils
folder from alas project, once
again, you can copy paste from
your last project, or you can
just go straight to the repo,
grab the verified dot j s, we're
going to go over these two
functions a little bit later,
but at least grab the verified
for now. And then we're gonna
start the function. So we'll do
module that exports equals async
function. We're gonna get get
named accounts, and deployments.
And we're gonna say const.
Deploy, log equals deployments
against deployer equals await,
get named accounts. So we'll do
a little log here just to get
started to do our basic NFT
doesn't take any constructor
parameters. So we'll say const
args equals a little blank here.
Then we'll do const basic NFT
equals await, deploy basic NF T,
exactly what we've seen before a
number of times at this point,
we'll say from Deployer. args is
going to be args. And then log,
it's going to be true. And then
we'll also do weight
confirmations. It's going to be
network dot config dot block,
confirmations, or one. Then if
we want to verify this, we're
going to once again do if it's
not development chains, dot
includes network dot name, and
process that EMV dot ether scan
API key will say log verifying
dot the dot await, verify basic
NF T dot address arguments which
are going to be blank, grab this
little log here, stick it right
underneath. And then actually in
our basic NF T. This should be
args not arguments. Now we have
a deploy script. Now we have a
basic NFT here in test data
deploy script, or any hh deploy
or yarn Hardhead deploy. And
oops, let's go back to the basic
kind of tea or mint and have tea
needs to return a UNT 256. Try
again. Get token counter also
needs to return a UNT forget you
into anywhere else. Nope. Okay,
looking good. And looks like
we're compiling well compiled,
deploying Well, now if you want
to deploy this to rink B, you
can. I recommend holding off
though, because we're going to
do that at the end. Now that
we've written a deploy script.
We've written the contract, you
already know what's coming next.
Yes, neat. What's next is the
tests now because we're not
actually learning too much more
here. I'm not going to walk you
through writing this test. I'm
going to challenge you now. How
to pause the video and write the
test out yourself and see how
far in this test you can
actually get. Remember, to test
it, you're going to want to run
yarn, hard hat test,
right, let's see if you can
actually write the test
yourself, then come back to the
video, see if your tests were
just as good or not as good as
what we did here. And of course,
you can always go to the GitHub
repo test sections. And if you
get lost, you can look at the
basic nft.test.js To follow
along. All right, welcome back.
Hopefully, you wrote some
awesome tests, taking the time
to actually do some of those
exercises is really going to
make you a much better engineer.
Following along with me, it's
awesome. But tinkering yourself
and trying to do everything
yourself is really what's gonna
make this stick. So I hope you
did pause the video. And hope
you did go ahead and try to
write the test for this
yourself, you've technically
just created a really
minimalistic NFT.
Great job. Let's kick things up
a notch. Let's move now to a
random IPFS hosted NFT where
we're going to do everything
pretty much programmatically. So
let's jump in. In our contracts,
we're going to create a new file
random IPFS, NFT, dot soul. Same
thing. spdx license identifier,
gonna be MIT pragma, solidity
carrot zero, point 8.7, or
whatever version you want to
use, will do contract random
IPFS NF? T, like so. So what is
this one going to do? So instead
of just minting any NFT, when we
meant an NF t, we will trigger a
chainlink VRF call to get us a
random number. Using that
number, we will get get a random
NF t that we're going to decide
on. And the random n of t that
we're going to use, it's going
to be either a pug a Shiva in
you, or a St. Bernard. So
whenever anybody mints NF T,
they're gonna get one of these
random three dogs. And we're
going to make this so that each
one of these dogs have a
different rarity, we're going to
make these dogs rare by
different amounts, say we want
the pug to be super rare, the
Shiva to be sort of rare, and
then the St. Bernard to be
pretty common. So probably it's
gonna be super rare Shiva in us
is gonna be sort of rare, St.
Bernard is going to be pretty
common, right? Or the most
common, if you will. So let's go
ahead and start building this,
we're probably gonna have to
make a function called like
request NF t, because we're
going to know that we're gonna
need to kick off a channeling
VRF request, we're probably
gonna have to make a function
fulfill random words, that's
going to take a un 256 Request
ID and a un 256. Array, memory
random words, as we've seen
before, we've done fulfill
random words in the past. And
let's let's even go one step
further, we'll make it so that
users have to pay to mint an NF
t. So this is going to be they
have to pay a certain amount of
eath to get the NFT and then the
owner of the contract and
withdraw the eath. So we're
basically paying the artists
here, we're paying the artists
to create these NF T's. And then
they can be the ones actually
actually withdraw the payment
for all these NF T's. And we're
also going to need, of course, a
function, token URI, which takes
a un 256. And this is once
again, same as our basic NFT
gonna be what this token
actually looks like. So let's go
ahead and get started creating
this. Now, because these red
lines are going to draw me
crazy. We're going to add some
visibility here, we'll make this
request NFT public fulfill
random words, we actually know
from the past is going to be
internal token URI is going to
be public. Let's build this
request NFT. And again, to
request a random number, go back
to EVM. Chains, we go to using
randomness, we can follow along
with the Dr. chain link again,
to figure out how to get this
random number. So since we know
we're going to be working with
chain link, we want to add at
chain link slash contracts. So
back in in our code base, we'll
add that in yarn add dash dash
dev at chain link slash
contracts, like so which was
perfect. And we can go ahead,
and we're going to import that
VRF consumer base V two and the
VRF coordinator interface into
our code because we know we're
going to use both of these. If
you want to just copy paste from
the docs, you absolutely can go
to pause here. And since we're
going to be using this view of
consumer base, we want to
inherit it. We're going to say
random IPFS and f t is V RF
consumer base V two and this
little, little wiggly line will
show up here saying This seems
to be override. So I'm just
gonna go ahead and add override
here. And this little wiggly
line is gonna stay there for a
little bit until we implement
the rest of the functions. So
let's go ahead and implement the
rest of those functions. Request
NFT, of course, is going to be
public here. And in order for us
to request an NF T, we're going
to need to call the coordinator
dot request random words where
we pass all this stuff in.
Right, so let's go ahead and get
all this stuff for our V REF
coordinator in our constructor,
so let's create a new
constructor. struct door. And
we're going to use the VRF
consumer base, the two
constructor to use to create our
constructor, the VRF consumer
base V two needs an address in
here for the VRF consumer base.
So we'll go ahead and we'll do
address VRF. Or did Nate Torre b
two. And then we'll pass this to
the VRF consumer base
constructor here, just by adding
that that red squiggly line has
gone away from me perfect. And
we want to save that address to
a global variable. So we can
call request random words on it.
So we're gonna go ahead up here,
we're going to say I underscore
var F chord. To me, Tor, we're
going to make this immutable VRF
coordinator. And we're going to
do it by saying VRF v2
interface, it's gonna be
private, immutable, you have
coordinator and then in our
constructor here, we're gonna
say IVF coordinator equals VRF,
coordinator v2 interface wrapped
around this like so. So we know
we're going to need this, we
know we're actually gonna need a
ton of these. So let's just add
all these variables in here,
we're gonna need the
coordinator, we're gonna need a
UNT 64 private, immutable, I
underscore subscription ID,
we're gonna need a bytes 32,
private, immutable,
I underscore gas lane, we're
gonna need a you int 32 private,
mutable, I underscore callback
gas limit, we're gonna need a
UNT 16 Private constants,
request confirmations, we're
gonna say it's gonna be three,
and then a un 32. Private
constant equals num words, which
is going to be one, and we'll
get this red squiggly line
saying it's mad at our our
constructor here. So let's go
ahead and add all of our
immutable variables in our
constructor. So we'll get the
VRF coordinator v2 from our
constructor will get the UNT 64
subscription ID, we'll get the
bytes 32 Gas lane, aka the key
hash, we'll get the un 256.
We'll do a UNT 32 callback gas
limit, then we'll go ahead and
do I subscription ID equals
subscription ID will do I gas
Lane equals gas lane will do I
call back gas limit equals call
back.
Yes limit.
Okay, a lot of variables set up.
But those are the variables that
we're going to need for the
chainlink VRF. Now we have all
these variables down in our
request. And if t we can request
a random number to get for our
random n of t, we're going to
say and our returns a yuan
tivity six Request ID. So in
here, we'll say request, Id this
request ID that we just
initialized I underscore VRF.
Core didn't a Tor dot request.
random words. And this should
look pretty familiar to what we
did in our lottery. I underscore
gas Lane comma, I underscore
subscription ID, comma, request,
con for nations. I underscore
callback gas limit. And then of
course num words and we can just
literally copy paste this from
the documentation or from our
last project, whatever you want
to do. So we are requesting this
random NFT here. Now here's the
thing, though, we want whoever
called this request function it
to be there and have tea, right.
And if we saw in our basic NFT,
when we minted the NFT, we call
this safe mint which needed the
owner and the token counter.
When we request a random number
four are NFT. It's going to
happen in two transactions,
right? We're going to request
and then later on we're going to
fulfill and it's going to be the
chain link node that's calling
fulfill random words. So if it
In the fulfill function, we just
do this safe meant message that
sender, the owner of this NFT is
actually going to be the chain
link node that fulfilled our
random words. So we don't want
that, what we want to do is we
want to create a mapping between
request IDs. And whoever called
this so that when we call
fulfill random words, which
returns with that exact same
request, ID, we can say, Ah,
okay, your request ID X, you
belong to the person who called
this request and of team, we're
going to create a mapping
between people who call this and
their request IDs so that when
we fulfill random words, we can
properly assign the dogs to
them. So up at the top, right
underneath here, I'm going to
call them VRF helpers, we're
going to create a mapping of un
256. To an address, we'll make
this public which we should make
it private, but we'll just make
it public s underscore Request
ID to sender. And then when we
call this request, and F T, will
set the request ID to sender of
Request ID equals to message dot
sender. Now, when the chain link
node responds with fulfill
random words, what we can do is
we can say address dog owner or
the NFT dog owner is going to be
equal to s Request ID to sender
of Request ID. This way, it's
not going to be the chain link
nodes that are going to own the
dog, but it's gonna be whoever
actually called requests. NFT.
Okay, cool. So we have a way to
request a random number for our
random NF t. Now, let's go ahead
and mint this random dog, this
random NF T for this for this
user. So we have the user now
using this mapping, what else do
we need? Well, we're gonna need
the token counter here. Let's go
ahead and we'll create a token
counter variable. So we'll
scroll up and make a new
section. And we'll say, un 256.
And then again, we'll just make
a lot of these public just to
make it easier, but you might
want to make this private and
use that same syntax we were
doing before do s underscore
since this is a stored variable,
token counter. And we'll grab
this token counter. And we'll
say you went to 56. New token ID
equals as token counter, now
that we have the dog owner, and
the token ID, we can go ahead
and mint this MFT. So we'll do
safe mint.
Owner, new token, ID and then
safe man is going to be squiggly
because our code is gonna say,
what is this? What is the safe
mint function? Where did you get
this from? Well, we're gonna
need to get it from open
Zeppelin again. So we're going
to go ahead and do import at
open Zeppelin slash contracts
slash token slash ERC. 721 slash
ERC. 720 one.so We'll say a
random IPFS empty is Vera of
consumer base, and also ERC 721
In our constructor, right after
our V RF consumer base, we're
going to put the ERC 721. And
same thing, we need to give it a
name and a symbol. So we'll call
this random IPFS NF T. Comma,
we'll just do Rin for random
IPFS NF team. Now safe mint
actually works and then it's
gonna be mad at me for this. So
I'm gonna do override just let
it stop getting mad at me.
public view override turns
string memory. Just that
squiggly line goes way. Okay,
cool. So great. So now we can
safe mint to the dog owner this
new token ID Are we done with
this? Absolutely not. Why not?
Well, we don't know what this
token looks like. And what we
set above is we want to actually
make these dogs different
rarities. So how do we actually
create these dogs with different
rarities, all we could do is we
create a chance array an array
to show the different chances of
these different dogs here. So
down below, we're going to
create a function and it's going
to be a public pure function
called get chance array. And
this is going to return you went
to 46 of size three in memory.
And this chance array is going
to represent the different
chances of the different dogs.
So we're gonna say return
10 3100 Or we're gonna say Max
chance value.
And up at the top under empty
variables. We're gonna say you
went to 56 internal constant,
Max chance value equals 100. So
by making this array, we're
saying index Zero has a 10 percent
chance of happening. We're
saying index one has a 20 percent
chance of happening because it's
going to be 30 minus 10. And
then we're saying index two is
going to have a 60 percent chance of
happening, because it's going to
be 10 plus 30. minus this 100.
This array that identified the
percentages of the different
dogs. We're saying the pug is
going to have a 10 percent chance,
Shiva in you a 20 percent chance and
the St. Bernard a 70 percent chance,
we're going to use it to give
this token ID that we just
minted its dog breed. So we're
gonna create a new function
called Get breed from modded
RNG. And the reason we're
calling a get breed from modded
RNG is exactly the same way. In
our lottery. We got a random
number, we're gonna say you went
to 56 modded RNG equals random
words of zero mod Max chance
value, we're going to mod any
number we get by 100. Doing it
like this, we're always going to
get a number between zero and
99. If random words zero mod Max
Chin's value is going to be
seven. That means we're gonna
get a pug. If we get 88. That
means we're gonna get a St.
Bernard, if we get a 45. We're
gonna get a what? That's right,
a St. Bernard, if we got a 12
We're getting a Shiva in you. If
the mod ID number that we get by
modeling this random word is
between zero and 10. It's going
to be pug between 10 and 30.
shiba inu between 30 and 100 St.
Bernard and that's how we get
these randomness values. So now
that we have this modded RNG, we
have this mod ID number that's
going to be between zero and 99.
Okay, this function called Get
breed from modded RNG. And this
is going to take the UN 256 mod
ID RNG will make this a public
pure function, and it's going to
return the breed of the dog. Now
the breed of the dog is going to
be an email similar to raffle
state that we did before. We're
going to do this right at the
top since this is going to be
what a type declaration or say
enum. Read, we're going to say
the zero with number is going to
the pug. The ones number is
going to be the Shiva in you.
And then the second one is going
to be the St. Bernard. So we
have the pug which is zero to
10. Shiva in you 10 to 30 St
Bernard 30 to 100. So get breed
from modded RNG public pure
returns breed. So we're gonna
loop through this we're gonna
say you intuitive six cumulative
sum equals zero, we'll say you
went to 56. size three memory
chance array equals yet chance
array. So we're getting that
chance array. So we're going to
create a little for loop we're
gonna say for you went to 56 i
It's gonna start with zero is
going to be less than the chance
array dot length. i plus plus
ran through that for loop here.
And we're going to say if modded
RNG is greater than or equal to
this cumulative sum and modded
RNG is less than the cumulative
sum plus chance array plus
wherever we are on the chance
array, then return breed of AI.
And then outside of this, we're
gonna say cume cumulative sum
plus equals chance array of I,
let's say moderate orangey
equals 25. And if it's 25, it
should be a Shiva in you,
because that's between 10 and
30. So we're saying if mod RNG,
which is 25 is greater than or
equal to cumulative sum, which
right now is zero, and it's less
than n, the Moto G is less than
the cumulative sum plus the
chance array of I which is going
to be 10 Return breed of I
cumulative sum is currently zero
plus chance of I which is 10 is
going to be 10. And this is not
true because Morarji is 25. So
since this is not true, we're
going to move to the second step
which is just cumulative sum,
plus equals chance right? So
cumulative sum will now be equal
to 10. And then we reached the
end of the for loop. So we'll
restart i is now one, so let's
try this again mod RNG is
greater than or equal to
cumulative sum Okay, that is
true cumulative sum is 10. Mod
RNG is 25. And mod RNG is less
than cumulative sum plus chance
re of AI, which is 30. So we're
saying 25 is less than 10 plus
30, which is 40. Return breed of
AI, this is true. So breed of AI
would be true and AI at the
moment is one. And if we scroll
up, that's indeed the Shiva in
you. So that's how this function
is going to work, it's going to
get us the breed from that
modeling bit. And then if for
some reason, some really wacky
stuff happens here, we want to
just go ahead and add a revert,
right, because we should be
returning a breed. But if we
don't return a breed, we should
just revert. So we're going to
create a new error at the top,
random IPFS NFT underscore
underscore range out of bounds.
The down below, we're just going
to say if for some reason you
don't return anything, just do a
revert random IPFS NFT range out
of bounds. And now we have this
function. Okay, so now we can
get the brief from a modded RNG.
So pack in our fulfill random
words function. Let's go ahead,
and we'll say, we'll uncomment
this will say breed, dog breed,
equals get breed for modded RNG
pass the modded RNG here, and
let's move this safe mint down
below us getting the dog breeder
so we can mint and add the dog
breed at the same time. So we're
gonna go ahead and safe mint
here.
Now we can do a few things to
set this dog breed here, we
create a mapping between the dog
breed and the token URI, and
then have that reflected in this
token URI function. Or what we
could do is we could just call a
function called Set token URI
and the openzeppelin ERC 721 You
have to set this token your eye
function yourself. However,
there is an extension in the
open Zeppelin code called ERC.
721 Uri storage and this version
of the ERC. 721 comes with a
function called Set token URI
where we can just call set token
URI. And this will automatically
update that tokens token URI to
whatever you set it as. So we're
going to use this extension this
set token URI in our contract.
And the way that we do this is
instead of doing token ERC 721
Year C 721 that soul will do
token ERC 721 slash extensions
slash your C 721 Your arise
storage. That's all. And we'll
say random IPFS is ERC 721 your
rice storage. Now what's cool is
that our constructor will still
just use ERC. 721 Because ERC
721 Uri storage is extending ERC
721. And then this contract just
comes with some additional
functions like set token URI. So
right after safe meant, we're
actually going to call set token
URI with this new item ID. And
then we're going to give it that
breeds token URI, we're gonna
give it a string here that
relates to whatever breed that
we just got based off the dog
breed here. Now, to do this,
what we could do is right at the
top and our NFT variables, we
could create a string array,
internal, Alt S dog token, your
eyes, we're gonna make this
constant where it would just be
this array of all these strings
that we created. But maybe in
our code, we want to make this a
little bit more variable. And we
want to parameterize this. And
that's exactly what we're going
to do. So we're going to create
this string array, internal s
underscore dog token, your eyes,
which is just going to be a list
of these URLs are these URLs
that point to stuff like this,
we're going to do that in our
code so that when we upload any
image that we want to IPFS we
can then upload this s dog token
you arise accordingly. In our
constructor, we're actually
going to take in another
parameter called a a string of
size three, memory dog token you
our eyes, we're going to pass as
a constructor parameter, these
different dog token you arise.
So we're going to pass it this
list of dog token arise. Of
course zero is going to be the
token URI of the pug. One is
going to be the Shiva in you and
two, of course is going to be
the St. Bernard. So we're going
to pass it this list of dog
token your eyes, and then down
in set token your eye from that,
that list that we created. We're
going to set the token URI of
this token based off of that
array of the UN 256 version of
that breed are casting this dog
breed back into you and 256 to
get its index. With that we now
have a way to actually,
programmatically get a provably
random NFT with different
randomness for different one of
these NF T's. Now, let's go back
up to our little, our little
comments we made here, limited
NFT, we trigger a chain link or
a VRF. To call random number, we
got the rarities down, we got
the minting down. Awesome. Okay,
we don't have this part, though.
Users have to pay to Minton NF T
and the owner of the contract
can withdraw the eath. Okay,
this is stuff we've already done
before, this should be pretty
familiar here. So back in our
request NF t function, we'll
make this a public payable. And
all we'll need to do is we'll
just say if message dot value is
less than some mint fee, and
actually let's go back to our
constructor, we'll create a mint
fee, you int 256 Mint fee.
And then we'll do you in 256
internal I underscore mint fee,
we'll make this immutable. And
then we'll just say I'm
intervene equals mint fee. If
message of value is less than
mint fee, you already know we're
going to do a revert, need more
eath sent, we'll create a new
air called need more eath sent
and actually we'll do air random
IPFS and ft underscore
underscore need more II sent
like that, copy this, paste it
here and boom. So now just by
adding this line, this is now a
payable function. And people
have to pay some mint fee to
mint their randomized NF t. Now
we're also going to want a way
for owner to withdraw. So we'll
scroll down a little bit. We'll
scroll down to here, CREATE
FUNCTION withdraw, this will be
public. And we only want the
owner to do this. So we could
create our modifier, you know, a
modifier again only owner, or
what we could do is use
openzeppelin. Again,
openzeppelin also comes with
some access code, or one of
them's this ownable code, and in
here, it already has the only
owner modifier for us, we're
just gonna go ahead and import
that as well. We'll do import at
openzeppelin slash contracts
slash access slash ownable dot
som, and we'll say contract
random IPFS. And if t is this,
this come ownable. And then
we'll make our withdrawal
function only owner. And so
whoever deployed this contract
is going to be set to being the
owner, which is what we want.
And when here, same as what
we've done, we'll do u and 256.
amount equals address this dot
balance. And then we'll do bull
success comma equals payable,
message dot sender, but call
value is going to be a mount and
then we're going to call
nothing. And then we're going to
say if not success. And we're
going to revert with transfer
failed, then on top, we're going
to do error transfer failed. I'm
just going to copy this a little
quicker, like so and then come
back down to transfer failed
paste it here. So we're gonna
revert random IPFS. And if T
transfer failed, perfect, so now
we have a withdrawal function
and a way for people to pay for
art here. Now we don't need this
token URI anymore, because when
we call set token URI, this is
going to set the token URI for
us because in the back ERC 721
Uri storage already has that
function laid out. So our
contract will already have the
token URI function and we don't
have to explicitly set it
ourselves. But we do have to
explicitly set some other ones.
We are going to need function
get meant fee will be a public
view turns you went to 36 turn I
meant fee will need function get
dog token your eyes, you went to
36 index, this will be a public
view which will returns the
string memory return s
underscore dog token your eyes
index will need function get
token counter. This will be a
public view turns you into 56
Return s underscore token
counter. Alright, so we just
wrote a ton of code here. And of
course as we taught you before,
we also are going to need some
events. So when we request an NF
T, we're going to emit an event.
So we'll omit NF T requested and
then we'll pass it the request.
ID in the message dot sender. So
up at the top will say event NF
T requested. So pet, take a un
256 index Request ID, and then
an address requester. And then
we're also going to make an
event for NF T minted for when
it's finally minted. And it's
going to take a breed, dog
breed, and an address, mentor.
So write down when we fulfill,
we're going to emit NFT. minted.
And it's going to take that dog
breed and then the dog owner.
Okay, we've just written a lot
of code here. So let's go ahead
and see if we can compile this
with H H compile, or yarn
Hardhead, compile. And Wow,
looks like we went ahead and
compiled it. This is great. So
all of our code now looks good.
Now might be a good time to take
a quick breather, we've just
written a lot of code. And it
might be good to just go over
all the stuff that we just went
through. A lot of this is
familiar, but it's still really
good to redo some of this stuff
and really get that muscle
memory and for these credit, an
NFT contract that when you mint,
one of these NF T's, you're
gonna get a pug a Shiva in you
or St. Bernard, based off of
some rarity, where the pug is
really rare. Ship it in you is
sort of rare in the St. Bernard
is pretty common. The way we do
it is we have this request NF t
function, which people have to
pay to call and it makes a
request to a chain link node to
get a random number. Once our
contract gets that random number
uses a chance array to figure
out which one of the NF T's
we're going to actually use for
this for that minting. And we're
going to set the token URI
accordingly. And we're going to
store the image data for this on
IPFS, which we haven't done yet.
So our deploy function for this
is going to be really the
interesting part of this
contract. But because we just
went over so much, if you want
to take a quick break quick
breather, and then come back, I
encourage you to do so we just
learned a lot. And we wrote a
lot of solidity code. So go take
a quick breather, and I'll see
you in a
minute. So let's go ahead and
get on in here, create a new
deploy, go to ploy, random
ipfs.js. And now this is going
to look really similar once
again, to the lottery contract
that we've already done. And we
can copy some boilerplate from
our code over here, we're gonna
need all this, we'll just copy
that, close it off with a little
curly and boom, we've already
got a boilerplate. Now, since
we're working with chainlink,
here, we are going to be working
with mocks again. So we're gonna
come back new file 00, deploy
mocks dot j s. And if you want,
you can just copy paste from the
earlier section that we did with
the with the raffle slash
lottery. Since we're going to be
doing the exact same thing here,
I'm gonna go ahead and pause and
you can copy paste from your
previous projects. Or if you
want, once again, you can just
come to the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
come over to the deploy. And go
ahead and grab the deploy mocks
right from here. If you grab
from the GitHub repo, we also
are going to be working with a
mock v3 aggregator, but I'm not
going to add that part in quite
yet, because we don't need it
quite yet. So go ahead and pause
the video right now. Copy and
paste the VRF coordinator mock
or pause the video and try to
write the mock code yourself.
Okay, great. So once you've done
that, we're of course gonna need
to concentrate ID network dot
config dot chain ID, because
we're gonna need to decide if
we're actually on a development
chain. So same as what we did
before then we're gonna say if
development chains that includes
network dot name, then we're
gonna say const VRF coordinator,
B to mock goes await ethers dot
get contract VRF. Core. The name
for the to mock similar to the
raffle we're gonna say let VRF
coordinate Tor v two address,
same, the VRF coordinator v two
address equals VRF. coordinator
v two mach mock that address and
then we're going to want to
create a subscription exactly
the same as what we did with our
lottery. So we're gonna say
const, TX equals weight VRF
coordinate tore V to mock dot
create subscription. And then
we'll do const TX receipt equals
weight, TX dot weight one. And
we're gonna get the sub ID from
this exactly the same way we did
it in the lottery section. So
we'll say that we need that sub
ID by saying sub subscription ID
will say subscription ID equals
TX receipt, dot events, zero.
That args got somebody. So
that's what we do if we're on a
development chain, else said the
VRF coordinate tore V to address
equals network config of the
chain ID dot VRF coordinate or B
to that then the subscription ID
equals network config. Chain ID
dot subscription ID. Perfect.
And then we'll just double check
our helper hard hat config. So
that Rigby has both the VRF
coordinator v2. And we're also
going to need a subscription ID.
So right now, I have our
subscription ID from our past
project from our lottery
project. But we can go ahead to
V or F dot chain link, we can go
to V RF, that chain link can
make sure we're on rink B here.
Let's see our other
subscriptions. And it looks like
we have one here. So I'm going
to copy this and paste it in for
Rigby. Now again, we can go over
to DockStar, chain link EVM
chains, contract addresses for
using reminisce to see more
parameters in here, especially
for Rigby and make sure these
are all correct. We have our
subscription here, we'll add a
new consumer very soon once we
deploy this contract if we're
actually going to use RankBrain.
So we'll do a little log here
with a bunch of hyphens. We'll
now get args equals, we'll make
our arguments here. And what do
we need, we need the coordinator
subscription, gasoline callback,
address, dog, your dog token,
your eyes and admin fee. So
we're going to need VRF
coordinator for the to address
subscription ID. And we'll need
the network config. Chain ID dot
gas lane. We need the network
config chain ID dot meant fee,
then we'll leave that work
config chain ID dot callback gas
limit
the right order? Yes it is. And
then we need the dog token your
eyes and the mint fee with the
done here.
Now what do we not have, we
don't have this array of token
your eyes. Now we can do this
one of a couple of ways. If you
go to the GitHub repo associated
with this, go to deploy, we
actually did the randomness for
oh three in the get here,
there's one section where we
just automatically say, okay,
great token, you rise is just
going to be these three. And
then if we can actually even
copy paste these CDs on IPFS,
these are the better ones that
actually do have the IPFS as the
image. And we can see them like
that. So we could just use the
stuff that I've already
deployed. And if you want to do
that, you absolutely 100 percent Can,
or what we could do is we get to
actually learn to upload
programmatically our own images
to IPFS. That sounds a lot
cooler. So let's go ahead and do
that. Now what I want you to do,
if you want to use your own
images for this, feel free to do
so. But if you want to just
follow along with us, then we're
going to go to the Hardhead NFT
FCC repo. And we're going to
grab these random NF T's from
him. So all you can do is you
can come to here. And we can go
ahead, we can right click Save
Image, Jas, we'll save it to our
downloads, let's actually create
a new folder, we'll call it
images. And the images will
create a new folder called
random, then we can pull it just
right into here, make the name
random NFT. And this is just
going to be plugged up png. So
we can do that for all of our
images. Now in our images tag,
we have the pug ship in you and
St Bernard. So we have these
locally. But we want to upload
these to IPFS. We want to upload
them in a way that anybody can
actually pin them and work with
them. So before we do all this
stuff, where we get the
arguments to deploy this
contract, we're going to need to
get the IPFS hashes of our
images. And there's a couple of
ways we can do this. We do with
our own IPFS node, which I've
already shown you how to do that
manually, we can also do that
programmatically. Now, I'm not
going to show you how to do this
here. However, if you go through
the IPFS documentation, you
actually can learn how to do
through the command line and
even through some scripts.
However, if we're the only node
that's running this, again, it's
kind of centralized. So ideally,
we'd want these images and these
token your eyes and this and
this token metadata on our own
IPFS node and some other nodes.
So the second way that we can
look at this is using something
like Hinata Hinata is a service
that basically you just pay to
help pin NF T for you. And this
is going to be the one that
we're going to be looking at
here. Now the issue with binotto
of course, is that we're just
paying once single centralized
entity to go ahead and pin our
data, we're kind of trusting
that they're actually going to
pin it and that they're not
going to go down. The final way
that we could look into actually
getting our data is was this
thing called NF T dot storage.
And if T dot storage uses the
file coin network on the back
end to pin our data now filecoin
is a blockchain dedicated to
pinning IPFS data and storing
decentralized data. For us, the
process is a little bit more
complicated. But NFT dot storage
makes it really, really easy.
Now, we're not going to go over
using NFT dot storage in this
video. However, if you want to
look into NF T dot storage, for
putting your data in the GitHub
repo associated with this
course, we do have a script that
uploads your code to NFT to
storage called in the utils
folder, upload to NFT. Storage.
And if you want to go and try it
out, I recommend that you do so
working with NF T dot storage
will be one of the most
persistent ways to keep our data
up. But it's still good to
upload your own data to your own
IPFS node, which we've learned
how to do manually and at least
get one other person also
pinning your data. And then
ideally, an entire decentralized
network, pinning your data,
which is what NFS storage helps
you do. But for now, for us,
we're just going to work with
pinata to keep it nice and
simple for this video. And then
uploading uploading our metadata
and our token, your eyes up to
IPFS will give us this list of
token your eyes for our three
dogs. So up at the top here,
we're going to do a little if
we're gonna say if process dot e
NV dot upload to pinata equals
true, yes, we're going to use
the string true like that. Then
we're going to upload to pinata.
Above here we're going to say
let's token your eyes. And we're
gonna say token your eyes equals
await,
handle token your eyes. And
we're going to create a function
called handle token your eyes,
which is going to upload our
code to pinata down outside of
this, we're going to create a
new function called async.
function. And we'll token your
eyes. And this is going to
return an array of token your
eyes for us to upload to our
smart contract, we're gonna say
token, your eyes equals this and
then way at the bottom, we're
gonna say return token your
rise, right, so we're going to
be returning this array here.
Now we need to do two things, we
need to both store the image in
IPFS. And then we need to store
the metadata in IPFS. So first,
we're going to create a store
images function. And this is
where we're going to actually
get to go to our utils. And
we're going to create a new
folder in here, we're going to
create a file called New File,
Upload to pinata dot j s, we're
going to add all of our code for
actually uploading to pinata in
here. Because again, pinata is
this service that we're going to
be using to just pin data for us
and work with pinata, we can go
ahead, try for free. And we can
create our own application.
And we're good to go. See the
setup here looks really similar
to an IPFS node, because that's
essentially what pinata is. It's
just an IPFS node, run by
somebody else. And we can say,
Hey, can you please pin this
data for us. So a manual way we
could do this is we could just
hit Upload Cid just like an IPFS
node and put the hash of some
IPFS file, and pinata would pin
it for us, we could also upload
a file or a folder just like an
IPFS node. But for us, we're
just going to leave this blank
because we're going to want to
do this programmatically,
because we're engineers. So what
we can do is we come over to our
profile, we'll open up API keys
and documentation. And the
documentation pretty much has
everything that we need to get
started. If you scroll down to
the pinata Node js SDK, this is
basically what we're going to be
working with, they've already
created an SDK for us that we
can work with, we're gonna go
ahead and install this pinata
SDK. So they're using NPM,
install dash to save, we're just
gonna go ahead and use yarn, add
dash dash dev at pinata dash
SDK, and they have all these
different endpoints, we can call
to actually pin data, we're
going to be doing pin file to
IPFS, because we're going to
upload our files and also pin
JSON to IPFS. Since JSON is
going to be the metadata, and
file is going to be the actual
image. And if you click on it,
it'll even give you kind of the
output of the SDK here. So back
in our code, now that we've
downloaded this, we can go ahead
and start creating this. So
we'll say const pinata SDK
equals require at pinata slash
SDK, and then we'll create a
function async function called
store images, it'll take an
images file path. So we're going
to use this function will pass
it our images, random n of t
file paths, and we're going to
have it store everything in that
folder to help us work with
paths. We're also going to
Install this path package. So
we're gonna do yarn, add dash
dash dev path, like, so, we're
just going to work with Fs as
well not Fs extra. So now that
that's up, we're gonna say
const. Path equals require path.
And in here, we're gonna say
const, full images, path, equals
path dot resolve, images file
path. So if we give that like
dot slash images, slash random,
you know, NF T or whatever, this
will just give us give you the
full output of the path. So
we're getting the full images
path, and then we'll say, we'll
get those files by doing const
files equals Fs. So we'll do
we'll grab s will say const Fs
equals require Fs just to read
these files in here, that read
DirSync. We're just going to
read the entire directory and
get our files back to read
DirSync full images path. And to
actually test that this is
working, what we're going to do
is we're going to do module dot
exports, equals store images.
And then back in our deploy
script here, we can just go
ahead and
comment out args. And we can do
import const, store images
equals require dot dot slash
utils, slash upload to pinata.
And in this script, we could
just do a little, we just call
this we could say await, or
images, and then we'll pass pass
our images location, maybe way
at the top, even outside of the
function, we'll say const images
location equals dot slash images
slash random and ft. So we'll do
a weight store images like that.
And we should be able to run
Hardhead deploy. Then if we add
some tags to this deploy thing,
module, dot exports, dot tags
equals, we'll say all random
IPFS. And then main, we do
Hardhead deployed dash dash
tags, random IPFS will also do
mocks believe, and I need to
create a test folder in here New
Folder test. And we need to add
that VF coordinator v2 Mock in
here. So again, I'm just copy
pasting the VRF coordinator v2
Mock from our raffle project.
Feel free to pause, copy, paste
it over, or again, everything's
available on the GitHub. So
we'll try one more time. Tags,
random IPFS, and mocks and boom,
okay, mocks deployed and perfect
pug dot png ship any png St.
Bernard PNG. Great. So we're
getting the files correctly
here. Now let's create a little
array for responses from the
pinata server. So we'll say
responses equals this. And we'll
say for each file index in files
for each one of these files in
here, we're gonna say const
readable stream for file equals
Fs dot create read stream of the
full images path slash files of
file index. What does this line
doing? Well, we're creating a
read stream. Since this is an
image file, it doesn't work
exactly the same as just like
push this data, right? We have
to create a stream where we
stream all the data inside of
these images. Because these
images, even though they're just
like a cute little image here,
they're really this kind of this
big file with all this bytes and
all this data in here, and then
we're going to send it by doing
try, we'll say const response
equals await. And this is where
we're going to do pinata stuff.
If we go back to the pinata
docks, there's some stuff about
keys in here. What we can do, if
you go to your profile, go to
API keys, we can create a new
key, we'll say this is an admin
key, why not? We'll give it all
the pinning access here. Maybe
we'll give it this, maybe we'll
just give it everything,
whatever you want to do. And
then we'll call this hard hat,
Free Code Camp key, create key.
Now we're going to want to grab
these and drop these into a dot
env. So the API key, go ahead
and copy, come back over here.
Open up our dot env. And we're
gonna call it our pinata. And
data API key equals that key.
We're going to grab the API
secret and say pinata API secret
equals that key. We don't need
this massive token here for what
we're going to do. But if you
want it, you can absolutely have
it. And then outside of our
store images, we're going to say
const pinata API key equals
price says, do you need that
pinata API key? And then can't
pinata. API secret equals
process dot E and V dot pinata
API secret. And then we'll say
const. pinata equals pin auta s.
DK of pinata
API key comma, pinata API.
Secret in order to work with
pinata, we need to pass it an
API key and API secret so that
pinata knows it's us who's
working with them. So once we
initialize this pinata thing, we
can now run pinata dot and then
do some pinata stuff, right, we
want to work with this pin file
to IPFS, which takes this
readable stream, which is why we
created that readable string, so
pinata that pin file to IPFS. Of
readable stream or file. And
then we're going to push this
response on to our responses
array. So we'll say responses
dot push response. And then
we're going to catch error, just
in case there's some weird error
here. And we'll just say console
dot log error, and then we're
going to return responses and
files. So we're going to return
all the responses from pushing
all these files up, and then the
files as well. Now, at this
current point, we can go ahead
and actually test this out
ourselves. So we have this in
here. If we go back to our
deploy, at the top, we have this
if process dot E and V dot
upload to Niada equals true, do
this stuff here, uploading to
IPFS. And the final thing we
need to do in here, of course,
is going to be require dot env
dot config, so that we can pull
in our dot env file. Down here,
we're just doing a weight store
images. So if we run this as is,
it should go ahead and store
images. So let's run that same
command, or that deploy random
IPFS and the MOX to run this
store images command. And if we
come back to our pinata, after
we run it, we'll be able to see
the code uploaded here. If we
run now, the script loaded IPFS
it'll give us a little bit of a
delay, because it needs to
upload these big picture files
to IPFS. or more correctly.
pinata, I'm gonna say uploading
to nada. And we could even say,
console dot log, working on file
index, done Excel. And okay,
great. It looks like it finished
running. So if we come back to
our project here, and we do a
little refresh, we see our three
files have been uploaded, and we
see they each come with their
own CID. Now, if you want, you
can go ahead and copy the CID.
And if you have your IPFS node,
what you can do, what we can do
is actually we can hit import
from IPFS. Paste it in here. And
we can say exactly what this is,
which is IPFS dot dot slash last
as the St. Bernard called St.
Bernard. Important. And now
we'll have it pinned on our
IPFS. I've got mine saved in a
little puppies file. Now that
we've got them uploaded, and
pinata do actually recommend you
pin your own on your own node as
well. So cool. So we've got a
way to get those images up onto
IPFS. Awesome
onto. Now that we've done that,
we're also going to need to
store the token URI metadata. So
let's go ahead and we'll delete
that for now. What we can do
back in here, is back up at the
top again, we can say const meta
data, template equals and we'll
create a metadata template. This
is going to have all the basics
of what we need for our metadata
for our token URI. So in here,
we'll have a name, set, it's
blank, we'll have a description,
which will also set as blank
will have the image which this
is going to be replaced with the
image URI that IPFS URI we just
created. And if you want to give
your NFT like any types of
stats, you can do some you can
create this Attributes section
like so. And if you give it like
traits type, cuteness, comma,
value 100. And this is how if
you wanted to create like
different cards or have
different attack, defense, HP
speed in different different
stats for your NF T's, you would
add them in this Attributes
section. Typically, you'd want
these attributes also stored on
chain so your contracts can
obviously programmatically
interact with these attributes.
But so now we have this metadata
data template. This is what
we're going to fill out for each
one of our dogs. Yes, we're
going to create a new function
in here called async, store
token URI metadata. And we'll
pass in the meta data to the
async function. And we'll pass
in the metadata that we get from
our script over here. So we have
this little template here. And
we're going to populate this
template based off of what we
get from storing data in IPFS.
So now we're going to write the
rest of this handle token your
eyes bit. And so we're going to
want to do in our data and V,
we're going to say, upload to
pinata equals true, so that we
can do everything and handle
token your eyes. So upload to
pinata, it's true, we'll scroll
down, we'll start creating this.
So the first thing we got to do,
obviously, we're gonna want to
get those responses and those
files, right, because it's in
the responses, pin file to IPFS
is going to return the hash of
the file, right, and we need
that hash, to add to our
metadata. So we're going to do
is down here, we're gonna say
const, responses, which is going
to be image upload, responses,
comma files, equals await, store
images, and then images,
location. And so this response
is, is going to be a list of
these responses from pinata. And
these responses are going to
have the hash of each one of
these uploaded files. So now
we're going to loop through that
list and upload each of the
metadata does. So we're going to
say for each image upload
response index, in image upload
responses.
For each one of these, we're
going to create the metadata,
we're going to create metadata
and then upload the metadata. So
we're gonna say let token URI,
metadata equals dot dot, dot
meta data template. So this is
some fun JavaScript, syntactic
sugar, which kind of means like,
unpack. So basically, we're
saying token URI metadata is
going to be equal to this stuff.
We're sticking all this stuff
into this token, your metadata
variable, now we're gonna say
token, your metadata. dot name
is going to be equal to files
of, of the index, dot replace,
dot png, dot png with nothing.
So files is going to be each one
of those files, right? It's
going to be dot png can be St
Bernard dot PNG, and it's going
to be Shiva dot png. And
basically, all we're doing is
we're saying, okay, cool, the
name inside of our token,
metadata is just going to be
pug. So we're just going to drop
the extension, basically. So
that's how we're gonna get the
name token, your AI metadata dot
description, is going to be
equal to and adore a bowl. And
then we're just going to get the
name, token URI metadata dot
name. So it's going to be an
adorable pug pup and adorable
St. Bernard pop or an adorable
ship and you pup token URI
metadata dot image, which is
probably the most important one
here, this is going to be, it's
going to be that IPFS extension
with the IPFS hash that we get
from the response. So we can get
that by doing image, upload
responses of the image upload
response index dot i IPFS. Hash,
so we can go to the pinata docs.
And we can see pin file to IPFS
returns in IPFS hash, the pin
size and the timestamp, all we
care about is the IPFS hash. And
we're going to use that to give
the our metadata image here. And
then finally, I'll do a little
console dot log uploading. And
then we'll say, token, your eye
metadata dot name, dot dot dot.
And now we'll have to store the
file or store store the JSON to
pinata slash IPFS. And this is
where in our upload to pinata
bit here, we're going to add
this function here. So we have
store token URI metadata. And
all we're gonna do in here, so
we're gonna say try const
response equals await, and nada,
that pin JSON to IPFS of the
metadata, right. And again, we
have, we want pin JSON to IPFS,
which is going to be really
similar. So we need to pass the
body, which is going to be the
JSON. And we have some optional
stuff here, but it's gonna give
us the same return the IPFS hash
pin, size and timestamp. And
then if this works, well, we're
just going to do return
response. Otherwise, we'll do
catch error. And then we'll just
do console dot log error, and
then we'll just do return null
and then we'll exports or token
URI metadata. And then back in
our deploy, we'll go ahead and
import this store token URI
metadata. And we'll scroll down.
And they'll do const, metadata,
upload response equals await,
store token URI metadata where
we pass the token, Uri,
metadata. And now finally, and
now with all of these metadata
is being uploaded are finally
going to have the token you
arise that we need. So we'll
say, token, your eyes dot push,
IPFS, slash slash, and then the
metadata response here, metadata
upload response dot IPFS. Hash.
So we finally will have this
array of IPFS hashes that points
to the metadata, and each one of
these metadata are pointing to
the image. And then we'll do a
little console dot log token.
You arise, uploaded, they are
and then we'll do another little
console dot log token your eyes.
Oh, all right. So let's go ahead
and run this. And let's see if
it works. In our pinata, we
should see both the images and
then also the metadata. If
process dot E and V dot upload
to pinata equals true, looks
like it is true. And we should
run this and handle token, your
eyes will both upload our images
with store images here and then
upload our metadata. We'll only
see it in here once because
again, it's gonna have the exact
same Cid right, it's gonna have
the same hash, so we won't get
duplicates of the same file in
pinata, or in our IPFS. So let's
open this up. Let's run this one
more time, or had deployed dash
dash tags, random IPFS and
mocks. Okay, it looks like we
almost worked uploading to
banana working on zero working
on one working on two metadata
template is not defined. Ha,
because I spelt meta data
template, meta data template,
let's spell things correctly.
Now let's try this again, it
working on zero is it working on
two image upload response is not
defined. I should spell
correctly. There we go. Let's,
let's do our caps correctly.
Let's try this one more time.
Okay, 012, uploading pug
uploading Shiva in you uploading
St. Bernard token your eyes
upload it and they're here. Now
if we grab this, and stick it
into our browser, or your IPFS
node, boom, we have them in
here. And what we can do is we
can grab this hash, we can jump
into our IPFS desktop, go to
files, we import from IPFS paste
it in here. And you know give it
the name etc, that we have it on
our own IPFS node as well.
Awesome. Now if we go over to
pinata give this a little
refresh, we can see we have
everything in here. So if I copy
one of these, and I go to IPFS
dot dot slash paste that in, we
can see the metadata in here.
And everything looks good. So
this is absolutely massive that
we've just done this because now
we can store data both on our
own IPFS node and at least one
other nodes so that if our
computer goes down or our server
goes down, and there's at least
somebody else who's done it.
Now we finally have this list of
token your eyes, we can finally
go back to our arguments. And
now we can do like this. And we
can upload all of those token
your eyes to our smart contract.
And then we're going to need a
mint fee as well for this. So if
we go to our upper heart at
config will create like a little
mint fee in here, say mint fee
is going to be whatever we want
12345678123456789 What we'll do
is 0.01 eath. So we'll even drop
this down one, we'll do it for
we'll do it for the Hard Hat
Network. And then we'll also do
it for Rinckey as well. We have
the arguments here. Now we can
finally deploy our contract. So
we'll do const random IPFS. And
if t equals await, deploy, if
the contract is random IPFS NF T
from Deployer. args is args. Log
is true. And then wait
confirmations is going to be
network dot config dot block for
confirm terminations, or one,
and great they might do another
little line here. We'll do the
verification bit. I'm actually
just going to copy that from our
deploy. Our basic I'm just going
to copy this it's going to be
code is going to be exactly the
same, except for we're going to
verify random IPFS instead of
and then actually we use args
instead of arguments, then that
is it. So we'll give this a
quick deploy test, HH deploy or
yarn Hardhead deploy. And it
looks like we almost worked we
almost got Everything's done.
Network config is not defined,
because we didn't import it. So
let's go ahead and import
network config from our helper
Hardhead. Config. So import
network config. We'll try this
one more time chain ID is not
defined, it's going to be chain
ID, that chain Id try one more
time. And awesome, it's at least
working for our heart Hat
Network. And then we can copy
this array, and just paste it in
here. Boom. And now we have this
token your eyes. And now back in
our dot env. Now we can set this
to false. Since we have all
those token neurons already, we
just run hard hit Deploy, we'll
just use the token heroes that
we already have uploaded. Yes,
we have done it. Now I know
you're excited to see this on
something like open See, you're
excited to see this right away.
But let's save deploying all
these to rink B for our last
thing, because again, deploying
to test nets is really slow. So
let's just wait until our last
bit and then we'll go ahead, and
we'll deploy this to rank B. But
before we write tests, something
that I noticed when I was
writing my test is that we
forgot to update the token
counter. So in here, before we
do, our safe, men will do s
token counter plus equals s
token counter, which is going to
be esto. Encounter equals es
token counter plus one. And
that's a perfect example of why
writing tests is so important.
Before you write any tests,
you're definitely going to need
to fund that subscription, which
we didn't do in here. So we need
to do a wait VRF coordinate Tor
V to mock dot fund, sub
scription. subscription ID,
comma will do fund amount, and
then just up at the top,
actually, we can even pull this
out too. Since that's not gonna
change at all. We can do let
token year I was like that looks
like const fund amount equals
cool. Or you could do you know,
you could also do ethers dot
parse. But as you know, before
we can even deploy to rink beam,
what should we do? Well, you got
it right, we should absolutely
100 percent write some tests. So we're
create a new file called random
IPFS NF t dot test dot j s. And
we can write some tests here.
Now, once again, there isn't
anything new that you're going
to learn in this test here, it's
going to be very similar to the
lottery tests that we've written
before. So here's what I'm going
to say, I'm going to highly
recommend once again, that you
try to write at least two or
three of your own tests, but
definitely write a test fulfill
random words. But I'm going to
encourage you to pause the video
now, please pause the video and
try to write some tests yourself
struggling with some of these
tests. And writing some of these
tests is going to be what really
gives you those coding muscles,
if you will, that's going to
give you the skills to keep
writing these tests and be
really fast and really
efficient. When you're building
these smart contracts. These
tests are the tests that protect
you from writing bad immutable
code. So please pause the video,
I'm going to copy paste from the
GitHub repo. But please take
this time to write some of your
own tests here.
Alright, great. Did you write
some tests? Hope you did. If you
didn't write some tests, pause
this video and go write some
tests. I promise you doing these
tests, writing exercises on your
own will help you dramatically
at this point, what have we
done, we've done some some
amazing stuff, we've deployed a
basic NFT with pretty much
nothing to it, then we've
deployed a provably random NFT
with random stats with random
traits with different rarities,
for each NF T's depending on
when it was minted, or who
minted it. We've stored the data
for this on IPFS. And we've
learned how to programmatically
upload our files to pinata,
which is another pinning service
for us. We learned a little bit
about NFT debt storage, which is
another way to pin data to IPFS.
And then of course, we learned
that if we wanted to, we could
programmatically pin data to
IPFS on our own node. But since
a lot of us aren't gonna be
running our own computers 24/7.
We went ahead and said, Okay,
well, we'll stick with pinata
for our default here. Now that
we've done all that, boom, got
another little checkmark here.
Now I got something to say we
don't need to host our data on
IPFS can actually host our data,
our metadata directly on chain
if we want to. However, there
are some pros and cons to IT
pros of hosting on IPFS, or
that's going to be cheap. And
the cons are that someone needs
to pin our data, right? There's
at least one person always needs
to have her data pinned, right?
It's decentralized, but you at
least need somebody to pin your
data, right? And using something
like file coin is a way to
incentivize people to pin that
data. But if you're not using
File coin, it's not necessarily
guaranteed the pros of doing our
SVG on chain NFT the data A is
on chain. And you never have to
worry about somebody actually
pinning the data. The cons are
that this is much more
expensive. These little images,
right here are actually
surprisingly large and storing
them on chain can actually get
pretty expensive. So we're going
to use some different images, so
much smaller images, much
cheaper images to work with
here. And if you want to see
another version of this, I have
another video, how to make NFT
art with on chain metadata, it
goes through pretty much what
we're about to go through here
as well if you want a second
reference, and there's a link to
this in the GitHub repo
associated with this course. So
instead of these PNGs that we're
using, we're going to use
something called SVG s. Now, an
SVG stands for Scalable Vector
Graphics. And these are much
much more minimalistic files
that we can go ahead and upload
to to the blockchain. So that's
why we're going to use them
because since there's so much
more minimalistic, they're a lot
cheaper to upload. Because
remember, the more data that you
upload to the blockchain, the
more expensive it is. Now in
this video, I make randomize SVG
data on chain. And here's kind
of an example of what one looks
like. It's just a whole bunch of
random lines. Not super
thrilling, but random and kind
of cool. And it's 100 percent. On
chain, these SVG is actually
work right in HTML. So if you
want to use these for your
websites, you can as well now
there's a link to this tutorial
in the GitHub repo associated
with this course, where we can
go ahead and try it yourself.
And we can actually play with
making an SVG, right, so they
have all these different
commands in this web through
schools.com/graphics/svg intro
dot ASP, you can see some of the
different commands, right, you
can make a rectangle you can
make a circle path is a big one
where you can say exactly what
the path or the line you want to
draw is going to look like.
There's a whole bunch of stuff
you can make in this SVG. And
the cool thing is, no matter how
big you make an SVG, the quality
is always going to be exactly
the same, because SVG just
explains exactly how to draw it
no matter how big or how little,
the image is going to be. So if
you want to learn more about SVG
is you want to play with SVG is
you know, you can come in here
and try it yourself. So with
that being said, that's what
we're going to store on chain.
So that's how we're going to
store this SVG stuff on chain.
But we're gonna go one step
further, we're gonna make this
dynamic, we're gonna make this
actually change based off of
some data on chain. If you go to
the GitHub repo associated with
this lesson, and you go to the
images, and you go to dynamic
NFT, you'll see two images, see
happy dot SVG, which looks like
this. And you'll see frown dot
SVG, which looks like this. So
we're going to make this NFT
dynamic in the sense that we're
going to say, if the price of
eath is above some number, then
we're going to have it be a
happy face. And then if it's
below that, we're going to make
it a frowny face. So our NFT is
going to change based off of
some real world parameters. And
this is obviously really
powerful and really cool,
because we can have an NFT that
changes based off stats, we can
have an NF t that changes based
off of really whatever, and
we're going to store all the
data 100 percent on chain, it's going
to be a little bit more
expensive. So that's what we're
going to be building here.
Let's go ahead, let's jump into
it. And let's do the final
contract for our ultimate NFT
section. So we're going to
create a new contract in here,
new contract, and this is going
to be our dynamic, SVG and F T
dot soul. And it's going to look
real similar to what we've been
doing. slash slash dynamic. SVG
and ft dot saw, slash lat spdx,
license identifier, and my team
pragma. solidity, Eric zero,
point 8.7. Contract, dynamic
SVG, NF t. Now let's talk about
what the architecture of this is
going to look like. It's gonna
look like pretty normal NF T,
with a couple of caveats. We're
gonna give it a min function to
mint, these NF T's are also
going to store our SVG
information somewhere. And then
we're going to need to have some
logic to say show x image or
show y image, right. And as we
know, that's really just going
to be switching the token URI to
say show X or show y. So let's
go into how we'd actually do
this. So first, we know this is
going to be in ERC. 721. So we
can go ahead and import that
from open Zeppelin. So we're
going to say import at open
Zeppelin slash contracts, slash
token slash ERC. 721 slash ERC.
721 That's all. Now we're not
going to call that set token URI
function that we call before so
we can just use the raw ERC 721
instead of an extension. So
we'll say our contract is ERC
721 and Now that we're making it
an ERC 721. We can say construct
dorm like this, then we'll call
the constructor of the ERC. 721,
which we're going to call this
dynamic SVG, and f t DSN,
dynamic SVG and s, t and f t,
like so then we're also going to
need a mint function. So let's
just create that right now say
function, mint and f t or
request NFT. And we'll be a
little bit looser here, we'll
say the user doesn't need to pay
any money for this. So this will
just be a public function. And
we're just going to mint them
and NFT. Same thing, we're just
going to call Safe mint message
dot sender. And of course, we
need that token count term. So
let's go ahead and in our top
will do you in 256, private s
underscore token counter, we'll
do token counter here. And then
after we meant we'll do tag
counter plus, there's gonna be
equals token counter plus one.
And then that's pretty much it,
we have a way to meant we've
done some of the basics here.
We'll even we'll be explicit
will say s token counter equals
zero to initialize it. But now
what is this token going to look
like? We want these to look like
SVGs. And we want it to be based
off the price of some asset in
our constructor, all right,
create a string memory. We'll
call it low SVG and a string
memory, high SVG. And in our
code will save this low SVG in
this highest V G. So these will
be the images, these will be
like the frowny face and the
smiley face that will just
import as input parameters here.
So as we know, we can make these
immutable since these are
probably not going to change. We
can say String, private, I
underscore low image URI. And in
string private, I underscore
high image URI. But if we just
pass the SVG data, right, the
SVG data is going to look like
what in this GitHub, I can go to
display the source blob here and
I can see exactly what this code
looks like this code here is
definitely not an image URI.
What we need is the image URI to
look something like this, right?
Now, the way that we're going to
pass it in is like with this SVG
code, right? Because we want to
just pass it the SVG code, and
then have the contract handle
everything else.
So how do we actually do this?
Well, what we can do is we can
create a function called SVG to
image URI. And on chain, we can
convert these SVGs from SVGs. To
image arise. So instead of
having IPFS, as their start,
we're gonna use something called
base 64 encoding, you can
actually encode any SVG to a
base 64 image URL. That's right.
It'll look something like this
base. 64 is group a binary to
text encoding schemes that
represents binary data. Or in
our case, our SVG data. Base. 64
is particularly prevalent in the
world wide web, or one of its
uses is the ability to embed
image files or other binary
assets inside textual assets,
such as HTML, and CSS, what we
can do, can actually convert all
this SVG stuff to a URL or an
image URI would be great, right?
That's exactly what we want, we
want to be able to convert this
to a URL or an image URI. Now,
if you take one of these images,
or these SVG images, like the
happy to have SVG, what we can
actually do in this happy dot
SVG is we can actually copy the
image address, which is going to
be the URL of this address. And
if we paste it back in, we'll
see justice file here. And in
this site, we can actually do
data type, remote URL, paste it
in here. And we can say encode
SVG to base 64. And down here,
we'll get this weird job role of
numbers and letters and stuff.
This base 64 encoding represents
the SVG that we just got and
what we can do in our browser,
we can type data, colon, image,
slash SVG, plus XML, semicolon,
base, 64, comma, and then paste
that massive thing in here and
Enter. And wouldn't you know it,
we get exactly that image back
up. So that huge, massive thing
here is the base 64 encoding of
this image. So with this basic C
four encoded image, we can use
this on chain as the image you
arrive for our images. And then
for our metadata. We'll just
bake that directly into our
token URI. You'll see what I
mean in a second. So we have a
way where we can actually
directly put our SVG code right
into our smart contracts. Let's
figure out how to do that. So we
have function, SVG to image URI,
so we know we're going to want
to probably do that same base 64
encoding on chain. We're gonna
100 percent do this off chain if you
want to save some gas but it's
kind of fun for To show how to
do this all on chain, so we'll
make this a public pure
function. And we'll have it
returns a string memory. So
we're going to give this
function an SVG, which we're
going to pass in from our
constructor. And we're going to
return a string, which is going
to be that base 64 encoded URL
that we just saw, while up at
our top will do string, private
constant, base S feed, base 64,
encoded SVG prefix equals that
right there. And we'll use this
to generate our SVG now, well,
we can do. And then we're going
to do string memory SVG, we're
going to encode this SVG in
basically for ourself by adding
the base 64 encoding on chain.
Now, we don't really want to
have to rewrite that ourselves.
So luckily for us, somebody has
already done this. And we can
see the GitHub repo associated
with this, this was created by
one of the LoopRing devs really
awesome project, if you want to
check that out as well. And
we're going to borrow this code
for our SVG on chain. So what we
can do is we can add this in
here, add their GitHub code,
where they have basically
everything that we need in here
to encode and decode basics
before, we can do yarn, add dash
dash Dev, base 64 Dash soul,
this is going to add their code
as a dependency. And once we've
added it, we can go ahead and
import it with import, base 64,
dash soul slash, base 64 dot
Sol. And this contract comes
with an encoder. So then we can
just do string memory, SVG base,
64, encoded, equals base 64 dot
ENCODE. And here's where it gets
a little bit weird.
We'll do bytes string, abi dot
ENCODE, act, SVG, and then we'll
return string API dot encode
packed, base 64, encoded SVG
prefix, comma SVG base 64
encoded, and just this function,
this SVG to image URI will take
in any SVG and spit us back out
a URL or URI that looks exactly
like this. Now, I kind of sped
through some stuff in here.
There's a whole bunch of new
stuff like ABI dot encode packed
that we did twice, what is this
ABI dot encode packed doing?
Well, let's learn about that. So
from a really, really high
level, this is basically how you
concatenate strings. Right, this
is how you combine strings
together. And we're going to
jump over remix to actually
explore this ABI dot encode pact
and this ABI encoding stuff a
little bit more. Now the section
that we're about to go through
is definitely advanced. And
we're going to be going over
some really low level stuff, and
how solidity works behind the
scenes, how the binary works,
and this thing called opcodes.
And all this crazy, low level,
tricky, difficult things to
understand. If you want to move
past this section, there are
timestamps in the GitHub repo.
To help you move past this.
However, I do encourage you to
at least try to absorb most of
this material, if you don't
understand it the first time.
That's 100 percent. Okay, this is more
advanced. Anyways, for most of
your basic projects, you won't
really need this information.
It's only later on once you get
more advanced that knowing all
this is really going to make you
a phenomenal solidity developer.
And when you approach this
section, when you approach this
sub lesson on EVM, opcodes, and
coding and calling, just know
that if you don't 100 percent
understand it the first time
that is okay, if you want to
watch this section a couple of
times fantastic. So if you want
to jump over to remix and follow
along, let's do it. Now in our
contract section, let's go ahead
and create a new file, we're
going to call it encoding dot
soul. And remember, all the code
that we're going to be going
with in here is going to be in
this sub Lesson folder of the
Hardhead NFT. FCC. And all the
code we're going to be working
with is going to be in this
encoding dot soul. And then in a
little bit, we're going to work
on this call anything that soul
so we're in this encoding dot
soul. And let's just make our
basic code here. So we'll say
spdx, license identifier, MIT
pragma, solidity, carrot, zero,
point 8.7, like that, do
contract encoding, boom,
compile, or Command S or ctrl S
great things are looking good.
Now remember, the whole purpose
for this is to first understand
what's going on here, and more
about this API dot encode packed
stuff. So let's first just write
a function that should owes us
wrapping API dot encode packed
with some strings and wrapping
it around a string is going to
return a string. So we could do
function, bind strings, or
concatenate strings. This will
be a public pure since we're not
going to be reading any storage,
we'll say returns string memory.
And we'll say return string, API
dot encode packed. I'm I'm
comma, space in here, I miss
you, like so. We need another
parenthesis here. Okay, great.
Now let's go ahead and deploy
this, we'll start a JavaScript
VM will deploy encoding
coding.so. We'll come down here,
we'll click Combine strings, and
we get that whole string output.
Hi, Mom, miss you. So what we're
doing here is we're encoding hi
mom misuse together into its
bytes form, because API dot
encode packed returns a bytes
object, and we are typecasting
it by wrapping it in this string
thing to be a string. And
solidity says, okay, yeah, bytes
to string, that's fine, that
totally works. And this API dot
encode packed are these globally
available methods and units. And
actually, in solidity, there's a
whole bunch of these, there's
this solidity cheat sheet, and
there's gonna be a link to this
in the GitHub repo as well, that
has a whole bunch of operators
and it has a whole bunch of
these global variables and
methods. You can see if we look
in here, we look for ABI dot
encode pact, we see ABI dot
encode pact right here, we
scroll down, we'll see some more
that we're familiar with as
well. Like, for example, message
dot sender, sender of the
message, message dot value.
There's a whole bunch of other
globally available methods and
variables that we can use when
we're coding our stuff. Now, I
will say though, in 0.8, point,
well, plus, you can actually do
string dot concat, you know,
string a, comma string B, if you
want to, instead of doing this
API to encode packed, but I
still wanted to show you the API
dot encode pack, because it's a
great segue into all this ABI
stuff that we're about to go
over. But let's focus on this
encode packed thing. So what is
actually going on here? Well,
before we dive deeper into this
encode pact, let's understand a
little bit more about what
happens when we send a
transaction. So when we compile
our code, and again, all these
pictures are going to be in the
GitHub repo. Remember back to
ethers.js, we had those two
files, we got a dot ABI file,
and a dot bin or dot binary.
Back in our ether symbol
storage, when we ran yarn,
compile. The two main files that
we got, were this symbol storage
that abi, which was this, you
know, this ABI thing that we've
become familiar with. And then
the simple storage dot bin,
which is the binary, which has a
whole bunch of just numbers and
letters and stuff we didn't
understand. And you can see that
in remix to, like if we were to
compile this, you get a
compilation details, you get a
whole bunch of stuff in here,
right? You can see the ABI in
here, which this is kind of like
a different way of viewing that
API, we also get this bytecode
bit and it's this object that
has the same stuff that has like
those random numbers and
letters. But this is actually
the binary this is actually
what's getting put on the
blockchain. It's this binary,
it's this low level stuff. Now,
when we actually send these
contracts to the blockchain,
we're sending like I said, we're
sending this binary thing.
That's exactly what we're
sending to the blockchain. And
remember how, again, back in our
ethers project, we saw what is a
transaction, right, a
transaction has a nonce, it has
a gas price guess limit to value
data, we kind of skipped over
the VRS a little bit, because
that's kind of that mathy
component of the transaction
signature. But again, back in
our ethos project, we did this
as well, right in our deploy
script, ended up sending a
transaction ourselves, using
just ethers. We passed a nonce,
a gas price, gas limit to value
data was this massive thing to
declare a contract, and then
also the chain ID. We didn't
work with the VAR s, because
ethers does that for us. But
there's also this VAR s
component that we don't bother
to look at. When we send a
transaction that actually
creates a contract, the two is
going to be empty. We're not
going to send this contract
deployment to any address. But
the data of this is going to
have the contract initialization
code and contract bytecode.
Right. So when we compile it, we
get all this code, like how do
you initialize the contract, and
then what the contract actually
looks like. So if you look at
any of the contracts that you
deployed, for example, I'm going
to look at our raffle that we
deployed. If you go to the
transactions of your contract,
we can see create raffle, right,
let's go to that transaction. If
we go down and click to see more
in the ether scan, we can see
this input data thing. And once
again, it's got all this random
garbled numbers and letters.
This is that binary data of the
contract initialization code and
the contract byte code right
what we send in our trend In
this action is this data thing,
we send this this weird bunch of
garbled nonsense. Now we're
going to head back to remix. And
I'm just going to leave this as
comments in here in the encoding
dot soul and the GitHub repo.
There's a ton of comments in
here explaining exactly what I'm
explaining. So if you want to
follow along there, you can as
well. But now in order for the
blockchain to understand, okay,
what do these numbers and
letters even mean? You need a
special reader cerium or the
blockchain needs to be able to
read all this stuff, it needs to
be able to map all these random
numbers and letters to what they
actually do. How does Aetherium
or polygon or avalanche know
that all this nonsense is
basically telling it to make a
contract, you kind of think of
it as saying, like, take off
your coat. The only reason that
we as human beings understand
what take off your coat means is
that we understand English,
We're all reading English, for
solidity. And for blockchains.
Instead of English, I read these
numbers and letters kind of like
words, just instead of take off
your coat, it's like deploy
contract, and the contract does
next XYZ and all this random
stuff. So this bytecode
represents the low level
computer instructions to make
our contract happen. And all
these numbers and letters
represent kind of an alphabet,
just like how take off your coat
is an alphabet. And when you
combine them like this, it makes
something that to us makes
sense, you can kind of think of
the alphabet for these as what's
called opcodes. If you go to
create a new tab, if you go to
EVM dot codes, we'll get to this
place where it just has a list
of all these instructions. On
the left side, you can see this
thing called opcode. And then
you can see name, so this opcode
section is saying, Hey, if you
see a 00 in this bytecode, that
00 represents this opcode stop,
which does what which halts
execution, if you see a 01
you're gonna do some addition
stuff, a 02 is multiply, there
are all these op codes that are
kind of like the alphabet, or
the language of this binary
stuff, right, and they go all
the way down to f f self
destruct, these op codes also
have, and that's what this is
reading. Right? So if we look at
our transaction here, and your
yours might be a little bit
different. Oh six, one says,
Okay, the first thing we want
you to do is the O six, one
opcode. And if we go to EVM,
opcodes, we look for six one,
it's saying push to place to buy
item on the stack. That's
exactly how it's reading this
any language that can compile
down to this opcode stuff down
to this specific set of
Aetherium opcodes, or EVM.
opcodes, is what's known as the
EVM, the Etherium virtual
machine. So being able to read
these op codes is sometimes
abstractly called the EVM, the
Etherium virtual machine, the
EVM basically represents all the
instructions, a computer must be
able to read for it to interact
with Aetherium, or Aetherium,
like applications. And this is
why so many blockchains all work
with solidity because solidity
compiles down to this bytecode
here, and polygon, avalanche
arbitrage Aetherium, they all
compiled down to the exact same
type of binary, and they all
have the exact same readers. Now
why are we telling you all this
stuff, you might be saying, hey,
Patrick, this is cool and all
but it looks like ABI dot encode
packed, all that does is
concatenate strings, abi encode
pack can do actually way more.
And if we look at these global
variables, API dot encode packed
is like what the third one down
the list because it's a non
standard way to encode stuff to
this binary stuff that we just
talked about, we can actually
encode pretty much anything we
want to being in this binary
format, basically. And let's
take a look at at encoding
something. So let's create a
function called encode number.
And this will be a public pure
function, since we're not going
to read any state, and we'll say
returns a bytes memory. We're
going to have this function
return a bytes object, we're
going to have it returned the
what this number is going to
look like but in binary, so
we'll say bytes, memory number
equals ABI dot encode one, and
then return number. So we're
going to encode number down to
it's a bi or it's binary format.
So I know a lot of times when we
say oh, what's the ABI what's
the ABI right? Previously, we
say, Oh, the ABI is, is this
thing, right? It's, it's all
these inputs and outputs. This
is kind of the human readable
version of the ABI. But again,
the ABI is the application
binary interface we want to
encode or numbers down to it's
basically it's binary, this ABI
dot ENCODE is going to be a
little different than like the
ABI that you see when you're
looking at compilation details.
This is technically like the ABI
technically is how to interact
with this contract. However,
it's not the actual binary
version of it. So we're saying,
okay, encode this number one
down to its binary version, so
that our contracts can interact
with it in a way that they
understand. So we're just saying
okay, Watch that number one,
let's make you machine readable.
And if we go, we compile this
and we deploy this right, let's
delete that that old contract,
we deploy this, we now have
combined strings and encode
number, we click it, we get this
big hex thing. This is how the
computer is going to understand
the number one. Now we can
encode pretty much anything
actually, we could encode a
string. So we'll say,
function, encode string, we'll
make this a public key here as
well. It'll return a bytes
memory, because we want to give
it that binary stuff or that
bites stuff. And we'll say bytes
memory, some string equals ABI
dot encode some string, and then
return some string. Now let's
compile that delete our old
contract, deploy that code
string, we get this big, big,
big object here. And this is the
binary. Now you'll notice
something here, there's a ton of
zeros, and those zeros take up
space, right, that's a lot of
space for the computer to take
up, even though they're not
really doing anything. They're
just kind of taking up space. So
solidity also comes with this
ABI dot encode tact, which
performs packed encoding of the
given arguments. And you can
read more about it in the
solidity docs, if you want. And
this is called the non standard
packed mode. And it does the
same encoding with some
stipulations type shorter than
32 bytes are concatenated
directly without padding, or
sign extension, dynamic types
are encoded in place. And
without the length array
elements are padded, but still
encoded in place, you can kind
of think of ENCODE packed as
sort of like a compressor,
right? It's the ENCODE function.
But it compresses stuff, if we
wanted to encode some string but
want to save space. And we
didn't need the perfect low
level binary of it. We could do
function and code string packed,
make this a public pure, and
have it return a bytes memory.
We could say, bytes memory, some
string equals ABI dot encode
packed once again, some string.
So we're doing a code pack
instead of a code. And we'll
return some string here, we'll
compile this and we'll see the
difference, right compile, we'll
delete our old one, we'll deploy
this. Now we have ENCODE string,
which again, that's what encoded
string is gonna give us and we
have encoded string packed,
which returns us this much, much
smaller bytes object. So you see
the size difference, if we're
trying to save gas, in code,
string packed is going to be a
way for us to save a lot more
gas. Now, abi dot encode pact is
actually really similar to
something that we've done
before, which is typecasting, if
we didn't function and code
string, bytes, public pure
returns, bytes, memory, bytes,
memories, some string equals
bytes, some string, turn some
string, these two are going to
look nearly identical, right? So
if we compile, we'll delete our
old contract, deploy this code
string bytes, which gives us
this and encode string pack
using the ABI to encode pack,
they give us the exact same
output, whereas encode strings
to give us this big piece. So
the two of these get the same
result. But behind the scenes,
they're doing something a little
bit different. And I'm not going
to go over exactly what that is.
But I've left a link inside of
the code here, if you want to
learn more, which is exactly
what we're doing in our NFT.
Right, we're doing ABR dot
encode packed, we're combining
two strings. By putting them
together, we're encoding them to
their bytes implementation to
their packed bytes
implementation, and then we're
just typecasting them back from
bytes to string. And that's how
we concatenate them. Now, at
this point, you
might be thinking, okay, cool.
Great, Patrick. I'm all set. I
understand this. I'm happy to go
back to my project. And if you
want to do that, absolutely go
for it and skip over this
section, but some other viewers
might be going okay, Patrick,
this is seems pretty cool. But
I'm sure this encode pacts in
this encode function aren't just
here to concatenate strings,
they probably have some other
function, what do they actually
do? Well, if that's what you're
asking, I'm glad you asked. And
I'm glad you're curious, because
we're going to find out. Now not
only can you encode stuff, like
strings and numbers, and really
anything, but you can decode
stuff. So I can say, function,
decode string, public, your
returns string memory, string
memory, some string equals ABI
dot decode. This is going to
take a couple parameters. So if
you look in the docs here, abi
dot decode, it takes as a first
argument, the encoded data, and
then it takes a tuple. You can
kind of think of it as a list
but not quite a list, a set of
types to decode this into and it
returns the number of parameters
that you gave it. So we might
want to say this string memory
some string Adding, let's give
it as input this encode string
function, the result of this
encode string function, right,
which again, is going to be this
big thing. So this is kind of
equivalent to sticking this
massive thing in here, but we're
just not going to stick the
massive thing in there, because
it's really big. So we're gonna
say, Let's decode the result of
ENCODE string, and let's decode
it into a string. Because we
need to tell solidity, hey,
we're going to decode this, but
it doesn't know what to decode
it into. It's like, okay, cool.
I can decode this, but like,
what, what do you want me to do
with it, and we say, Oh, this is
a string, so decode it into a
string. And then we can do
return some string. Now, once
again, we deploy that old
Cotters, we delete the last
contract, we deploy this new
one. So in code string, and code
string, whereas in code, string,
and code string returns this
massive thing, as a human being,
we're like, God, I can't read
that computers can read that.
But we can't really read that.
So we say, okay, let's decode
that back into its string form,
we hit decode string, and we get
back some string. And now we can
actually multi encode and multi
and decode, right, we can encode
as much stuff as we want. So I
can say function, multi ENCODE,
public pure, returns bytes
memory, we're going to encode a
couple of things, we'll say
bytes, memory, some string
equals ABI dot encode some
string, comma, it's bigger. So
we're going to encode two
strings here, we're gonna encode
some string, and it's bigger. So
we have two strings, we're going
to encode and we'll return some
string, even though it's you
know, bytes. And then we can
actually multi decode. So we'll
say function, multi decode, this
will be a public pure returns,
we'll say it returns two
strings, string memory, and
string memory. And instead of
doing string memory, some string
equals API decode, we'll say,
string memory, some string,
comma string memory, some other
string. So we're gonna get to
returns equals Avi dot decode.
Let's decode this multi encode
result, which is the doubly
encoded strings into a string
and another string. And then
we'll return both of these are
some string, there we go. Now
we'll return some string, and
then some other string,
I need a semicolon here. So now
when we deploy this, let's close
this out, deploy this new one,
right, we now have this multi in
code, which gives us this even
bigger bites object, right?
Because this is two strings
encoded. And now if we hit multi
decode, take a second, what do
you think it's going to put out
output? Let's go ahead and hit
it. Now it's gonna give us two
strings, right, it's gonna give
you these two strings, some
string, it's bigger. So we can
tell solidity to encode a bunch
of stuff. And then we can even
decode it by telling it, okay,
this big object here, it's two
strings combined, and then we
decode it. Now you can even
multi encode with that encode
pack thing, right? We could do
function, multi encode packed,
public pure returns, bytes
memory, and then bytes memory,
some string equals ABI dot
encode packed some string,
comma, it's bigger than return
some string, we could do this,
right, but this is going to give
us the packed version of these
two strings. So the decoding
actually isn't going to work on
this because this is packed
encoding. So if we tried to do,
I'm gonna say this doesn't work.
Try to do function, multi
decode, packed, public pure
returns, string memory, string
memory, some string equals Avi
dot decode multi encode packed
in a string and have exactly
what we did above to, if we do
return some string, what do you
think's gonna happen? Let's,
let's try to delete the old
contract, deploy a new one.
We'll do multi decode, packed,
multi encode multi decode,
packed, and we actually just get
an error. solidity basically
goes, Yeah, this looks like it's
packed. I don't know how to
decode that. But instead, what
we can do is we can do function
more to string cast packed like
this a public pure returns
string memory, string, memory,
some string equals string, multi
and code packed, return some
string. This one will work right
because again, this pact
encoding is kind of similar to
just type casting. So we'll
compile will redeploy multi
string cast pact, we get some
Trying, it's bigger, right? And
we don't have a space here. But
we should have put a space in
there. Now that we've learned
more about this in ABI dot
encode and decoding, and we know
that okay, this is what the
computer, this is, what
Aetherium. This is what the EVM,
or any EVM compatible chain is
looking for. It's looking for
this bytecode. It's looking for
this, this binary stuff. And we
just learned a little bit more
about how to encode different
variables into the binary into
that data bit. Well,
what do we do now? Now since we
know that our transactions are
just going to be compiled down
to this binary stuff, what we
can do then is we can actually
populate this data value of our
transactions ourselves with the
binary that code is going to
use. So here's our transaction
for a contract deployment, the
data field of the contract
deployment is going to be all
that binary code of the contract
for a function call, the data
piece is going to be what to
send to the address what data
what function to call on the to
address. Let's look at another
one of our transactions on ether
scan right on one of our
contracts, you don't have to I'm
going to look at enter raffle
from a previous section. And if
we select down, we look at input
data. It says function enter
raffle method ID. But if we look
at the original, this is what's
getting sent in the data field.
It's this binary, it's this hex
it's this weird, low level bytes
thing. This is how the Ethereum
blockchain or the or whatever
EVM chain you're working with
knows which function to call, it
translates this into a function.
And we can do the exact same
thing and call these functions
ourselves. So what we can
actually do with this crazy
newfound data and coding stuff,
what we can actually do is send
the data field of a transaction
ourself, in a transaction call
back in this ether throwback
where this data thing was the
contract creation code. Well,
instead, we could populate this
data thing with our function
call code, the exact function
that we want to call in the
binary in hex addition. Now you
might be thinking, Oh, well, why
would I do that, I can always
just use the interface, the ABI,
all that stuff, well, maybe you
don't have that maybe all you
have is the function name, maybe
all you have is the parameters
you want to send. Or maybe you
want to make your code, be able
to send arbitrary functions, or
make arbitrary calls or do
random really advanced stuff,
right, that's where sending our
function calls directly by
populating this data field is
going to be incredibly
important. So remember, I said,
you're always going to need the
ABI, and the contract address,
send a function. Now, when I
said, you always need the API.
Originally, we were kind of
talking about this thing, this
big, this big thing, which is
cool, which is the API. But this
is like the human readable API,
you can also do it with the non
human readable API. And
additionally, you don't need all
this stuff, you can really use
just the name of a function, and
then the input types to send a
function call. So the question
is, then, okay, how do we send?
How do we send transactions that
call functions with just the
data field populated? And then
the next question is, how do we
populate the data field? What do
we populate the data field with
to make one of these function
calls? And then how do we send
these transactions slowly,
actually has some more low level
keywords, namely, static call
and call we actually we've used
call in the past before, does
this code look at all familiar
to you? Well, it should, because
this is, we use a similar setup
in our fulfill random words for
our lottery, right, we sent
money doing this recent winner
dot call, right? Recently, it
was the address of the recent
winner, and we did not call. And
then we have this weird stuff in
this brackets here, and then
nothing in the parentheses. So
we did actually, essentially, we
use this call keyword
previously, but we didn't really
tell you what it did. So call is
how we can call functions to
change the state of the
blockchain. Static call is
basically how at a low level, we
call our view, or pure
functions, write static calls
gonna be like, okay, don't
change the state of the
blockchain with this one, just
give us the return value. So
this is kind of similar to like
a view or a pure function at low
level, there's also a Send word
but like, basically forget about
it. We're just gonna be working
with call, instead of call. And,
you know, later on, we'll
learn about another one called
delegate call. But don't worry
about that for now. Recent
winter duck call like this, in
these little squiggly brackets,
we said, Okay, we updated the
value directly of our
transaction in solidity. So
which again, if we have these
transaction fields, and we just
directly updated value in these
little brackets, right, we can
also directly update gas limited
gas price in these little
brackets if we wanted to as
well. And in here, these
parentheses is where we're going
to stick our data. Since all we
wanted to do with our
withdrawal. function previously
was send money. We said, Okay,
send money change the value that
we're going to send. But don't
pass any data, keep that data
bit empty, which is why, again,
remember how we hit this button
before, right and we had called
data be empty, that's
essentially running this command
with called data be empty with
this section be empty, and then
just updating the value that we
set with the transaction. And so
it's this section that we can
use to populate data to actually
call specific functions. We're
going to put a whole bunch more
comments here. So when our
squiggly brackets, we're able to
pass specific fields of a
transaction like value. And in
our parentheses, we're able to
pass data in order to call a
specific function. But in here,
there's no function to call
since we were just sending them
if we want to call a function or
send any data, we can do this in
the parentheses. And I think I
spelt that wrong. Now, we've
learned a ton here. So let's do
a quick refresher of what we
just learned. And then we're
going to actually learn how we
can call any function just by
using this syntax here. Well, we
learned from really high level,
if we want to combine strings,
we can do ABI dot encode packed
and then typecast that to a
string. And in newer versions of
solidity you can do, you can do
string dot concat, you know, Hi,
Mom, come on, miss you. In newer
versions of solidity. This works
as well, but not in older
versions of solidity. Then we
learned a lot about some low
level stuff we learned, okay,
when we compile our contracts,
we get an ABI file, and this
weird binary thing that numbers
and letters stuff that gets when
we deploy a contract that gets
sent in the data field of our
contract creation transaction.
So for contract creations, the
data is populated with that
binary code for function calls
is going to define which
functions to call in with what
parameters and this is what
we're gonna go over next. Now,
we learned that we can actually
encode stuff into this binary
into this low level code. And
any program any process that can
read this low level stuff and
execute accordingly, read this
EVM stuff, read the specific
binary that Aetherium has
specified, or the EVM has
specified is considered EVM.
compatible. We can encode
numbers, we can encode strings,
we can encode pretty much
anything we want to encode. To
save space, we do encode packed,
we can decode stuff that we've
encoded, but we can't decode
stuff that we encode packed, we
can multi encode stuff, and then
multi decode stuff. And then
finally, we can use this call
function and add data in here to
make any call that we want to
any smart contract. And this is
what we're going to learn next.
Alright, so now's a great time
to take a break, because we just
learned some really difficult
concepts. And like I said, if
you don't get it the first
time, that is okay. Alright,
welcome back. Now that we've
learned about this encoding
stuff, let's learn how we can
populate this parenthesis this
data field, so we can call any
function and we can do
essentially, what the blockchain
is going to do at the low level,
we can work with just that
binary, we can work with just
that bytes, we can work with
that hex to interact with our
smart contracts. So let's create
a new file. And we're gonna call
it call anything, that's all
start off with spdx, license
identifier, MIT. And let's talk
about this. Now in order to call
now in order to call a function
using only the data field of the
call, we need to encode the
function name, and the
parameters that we want to add,
right, because when we call a
function, we call the function
name. And we call the
parameters. So we need to encode
these down to the binary level
so that the EVM, or these
Aetherium based smart contracts
and solidity stuff can
understand what's actually going
on. In order to do this, we're
going to need to work with two
concepts to encode the function
name so that the EVM or solidity
can understand it, we actually
have to grab something called
the function selector. Now the
function selector is going to be
the first four bytes of the
function signature. And the
function signature is just going
to be a string, which defines
the function name of parameter.
Now, what does this actually
mean? Well, if we have a
transfer function, this right
here is known as the function
signature. So the function name
is going to be transfer. And
it's going to take an address
and a un 256 as its inputs, if
we encode this transfer
function, and then we take the
first four bytes of it, we get
this, which refers to the
function selector. So that's how
solidity knows. So in the
bytecode, in the binary code,
this function selector is how
slitting knows Oh, they're
talking about the transfer
function they want me to call
the transfer function. And this
is one of the first things that
we need to use call to call any
function that we want, we need
to get the function selector and
we can get it a number of
different ways but one of the
ways is by encoding the function
signature and grabbing the first
four bytes. So we'll create this
contract we'll do pragma
solidity zero point 8.7 Say
contract, call anything. And
we'll give this to stored
variables, give the to stored
variables and address public s,
underscore some amount, or some
address, and then you in 256,
public s underscore mount. And
then we'll create a function
called transfer function
transfer. Now normally in here,
we would actually do like
transfer for like an ERC 20
transfer, but we're just going
to do address some address, and
then you add 256 amount, amount
here, we'll make this a public
function. And then all we'll do
is we'll set S, some address
equals some address, and then s
amount equals amount. So here's
gonna be the function that we're
going to work with. And the
function selector for that
function is this, the function
signature is this. So it takes
an address some address amount,
that gets boiled down to the
function selector, and the
function signature. And of
course, in our bytecode, there's
going to be some code saying,
Okay, here's what this function
does, blah, blah, blah. So we
can actually even write a
function to get that function
selector. So we can say,
function, get selector and I'm
gonna say get selector one,
because I'm gonna show you a few
ways to get the function
selector, we'll make this a
public pure. And we'll have this
return a bytes for selector, we
could say select or equals bytes
for, and then we hash with a
check to 56 of the bytes of that
signature, which is transfer.
And it takes an address and a
UNT 56. Right? If we compile
this, and then we run it, let's
get rid of our old contract,
deploy, make sure we're on call
anything, if you have the other
one up. In here, now we have a
couple of things, we hit Get
selector one, we get this Oh X,
a 905, blah, blah, blah, right.
And that's the same as the
example I just gave. So this
right here tells solidity tells
our smart contract, okay, when
we make a call to this contract,
if you see this in the function
data, this is referring to our
transfer function with an
address and a un 256 as input
parameter. So we see address you
into 56. Our function knows to
execute this data here. Great.
And then of course, sml, and S
address are zeros. Now, while
we're here, we can also see,
okay, what happens if we call
the transfer function, right? It
takes an address and an amount,
so let's just give it its own
address or an address. And we'll
do 777 for an amount. If we hit
transfer, we have the log up,
right, we'll get a little
checkmark here saying success.
Now, if we hit S amount, we'll
get 777. And then the address
will be the same, right? So
that's us directly calling
transfer. When we directly call
transfer, we're basically
saying, hey, grab this function
selector, and then do some other
stuff, which we'll we'll tell
you the other stuff in a minute.
Now we have the function
selector. Okay, great. What else
do we need, we also now need the
parameters we want to add. So
we're going to need to encode
those parameters with our
function selector. So what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say
function, get data to call
transfer. And in here, we're
just going to have this get data
to call transfer, we're going to
have it take these input
parameters, and we're going to
encode these to work with our
function selector, we're gonna
say address, some address. And
if it is x, amount, public pure
returns, bytes memory.
And then we can return and use
one of those ABI and codings
from the cheat sheet. Now, so
far, we've just been doing API
and code for a lot of our
encoding. So it since we have
the function selector, we can
actually do ABI dot encode with
selector. This ABI encodes the
given arguments starting from
the second and prepends, the
given four byte selector. When
we do in Cobra selector, we're
just sticking our selector onto
the data that we're going to
give it. So we're going to do
return API dot encode with
select door. And we're going to
pass it the result of get
selector one, and then we're
going to give it some address,
and amount. So what this is
going to do, it's gonna give us
all the data that we need to put
in that data field of our
transaction, to send to this
contract to let this contract
know, hey, go use the transfer
function, pass in some address,
and then an amount. And then if
we compile this, we run it,
let's delete our old contract,
we'll deploy up, we now got a
new function called Get Data to
call and transfer, we'll just
pass you know, we'll just pass
this contract address and then
we'll also do 777 again. And so
this thing right here is what
we're going to put into the data
field of our transaction in
order for us to call transfer
from anywhere. So this is the
bytes This is the binary encoded
data of Hey, call the transfer
function with this address that
we specified. with, you know,
777 Mt. So what we can do once
we have all this, we can
actually call our transfer
function without even having to
directly call it. So what we can
do is we can say function, call
transfer function directly, or I
guess with binary might be a
better title, but you get the
gist, we'll say address some
address, you in 256 amount,
we'll make this a public
function. And we'll have a
returns a bytes four and a bool.
You'll see why in a minute. And
we'll do that same call thing
that we did to send our raffle
money. So what we'll do is,
before we did recent winner dot
call, right, we're going to do
some address. And then for us,
we're going to address this dot
call. And then we're saying this
contracts address which we could
put any address here address dot
call, and we're going to call
the encoded data that points us
to the transfer function with
some parameters. So we're going
to do address this.com. And we
could just do get data to call
transfer
address amounts, right, we could
do it like this. Or we could do
it kind of the wrong way. We
could do ABI dot and code with
select dorm, get selector one,
comma, some address, comma
amount. And actually, there's no
semicolon there, sorry. So those
are going to be the same. And
this dot call thing, right, it's
going to return exactly what we
saw before, it's going to return
a bool success. So whether or
not the transaction was
successful, and then bytes,
memory, returned data, which is
going to be you know, whatever
the call returns. So right, and
this is where we put like
require success, right. But for
us, we're just going to return
bytes, four bytes for a return
datum, and then success. So
we're just going to return the
first four bytes of whatever
data we get returned. And then
we're going to return whether
this was successful or not. So
this function is going to have
us directly call the transfer
function by passing these
parameters without us having to
do like contract dot transfer,
or, or transfer whatever, right.
And you can do this across
multiple contracts across
different contracts, just by
changing the address that you
call on. So let's go ahead and
compile this. We'll run this now
we'll delete our old contract,
we'll deploy call anything. Now
if we if we were. So right now
sml, and estimators are both
zero. Now, if we do call
transfer function directly, and
we'll pass in this one's
address, and then we'll do 777.
Now, if we pull up the logs, we
hit this, we're gonna get this
transaction response here. But
if we scroll down, we'll ever
see the decoded output, which is
a bytes for of just a bunch of
zeros, right? Because our
transfer doesn't actually return
anything. So it's just gonna be
a whole bunch of zeros, and then
our Boolean true, which means it
was successful. So since it was
successful, these two should
have changed based off of that.
So let's go ahead and try them
out. And we do indeed see that
they're changed. So we have just
directly called this transfer
function without having to call
the transfer function itself, we
can also do encode with
signature instead of selector.
So if we go to our cheat sheet,
there's also this encode with
signature down here, which takes
the string memory signature, and
it's equivalent to doing ABI dot
encode with selector bytes for
CAC bytes, you know, signature,
it's, it's equivalent to doing
exactly what we did up here. But
it does this step for us. So we
could copy this whole thing,
paste it down here, right, and
we could do, instead of encoded
with selector, we can do encode
with SIG netshare, the function
signature, and then we'll copy
our function signature from up
here, paste that in here.
Compile, we ran into a
compilation error, up, these are
the same call transfer function
directly SIG, called that
compile, leader, old contract,
deploy. Now these two are both
zeros again. Now if we copy the
contract address, we do call
contract call transfer function
directly SIG. We paste that in
here, we do 777, we call it, let
me check these we can see that
that does the exact same thing.
So this is API dot encode with
signature. This is abi dot
encode selector. Encode with
signature just turns us into the
selector for us. That's all up
here, we just, we encoded this
selector ourselves. Now, there
are a whole bunch of different
ways to get the selectors. And
we're not going to code these
out ourselves. I'm just gonna
say a bunch of different ways to
get selector. And who knows why
why you might want to use one of
these other reasons, right?
There's there's a ton of reasons
why you might want to get the
selector a different way. And
here's some now in this video,
we're not going to explain or go
over all these different all
these different function
selector getting methods. But if
you go through them in the
GitHub repo associated with this
course, they all have a ton of
comments to explain what they're
doing. Well, we are going to
show you though, it's actually
how to contracts can interact
with each other without actually
having all the code for each
contract. So we're going to make
a second contract that has all
this binary this byte
information to call the transfer
function on a different
contract. And we're gonna show
you how that can work. This is
just another contract that I've
made called call function
without contract. Actually, down
here, we're going to call the
transfer function, just by using
the address and the function
selector signature and stuff,
we're going to update these
storage variables in our call
anything contract from another
contract just by doing this
binary calling, if you will,
right, so let's compile, it's
going to deploy, we can actually
leave this up right, we can
leave this up is let's deploy
our call function without
contract, we'll pass it as an
input parameter, the call
anything contract address, we'll
deploy it. Now in here, I can
call the transfer function
directly by you know, maybe I'll
switch it to this, this contract
address this new contract
address, and we'll give it a new
number of 123. Right, and we'll
click call transfer function.
And then when we go back up
here, we see that this has
indeed been updated. Now doing
this call stuff is considered
low level. And it's a best
practice to try to avoid it when
you can. So if you can import an
interface, it's much better to
do it like that. Because you're
going to have the compiler on
your side, you're going to be
able to check to see if your
types are matching and all this
other stuff. So usually doing
these low level calls some
security auditor checkers might
say, hey, like this books been
out a little bit, you doing this
low level stuff.
But with that being said, You
have just learned a ton about
lower level solidity. This is
some really advanced stuff. And
like I said, if this was hard,
if you're kind of confused here,
don't worry, you can always come
back to this section and try it
again, when you're a little bit
more advanced, if you want to
try to understand it all now.
Awesome. Absolutely, we've left
some links in the GitHub repo
associated with this lesson that
I definitely recommend you check
out one of the ones you should
definitely check out, it's going
to be this deconstructing
solidity by openzeppelin, it
really breaks down exactly
what's going on behind the
scenes of a contract. If you
want to learn more about
opcodes, about low level stuff,
definitely give this a read, it
is a phenomenal read,
essentially, it breaks down a
little bit more than what we
went over here. A couple other
videos as well. And I've left a
whole bunch of links in here
too. With that being said, here
we are back in our NFT. And now
we know all about this ABI dot
encoding stuff, right and what
it does, and we know that ABI
dot encode packed, the way we're
using here is just a way to
concatenate strings. And we're
not using ABI dot encode for
really any of its crazy
superpowers, but we might in the
later section of this course. In
other case, so we do use this
base 64 dot encode thing that
we've imported, right, we
imported this base 64 dot encode
so that we can encode our SVG
that we pass it in to its base
64 encoding. I'm going to copy
paste an example here, you don't
have to do this. But like, for
example, we'll pass it in like
SVG width equals blah, blah,
blah, all this SVG stuff, kind
of similar to what I was showing
you before, we pass that in as
an input parameter here, and
output it, we're gonna get the
base 64 encoding of it, we're
gonna get this massive kind of
string here. We will test this
later to make sure that this
works. Normally, if I added a
function in like this right now,
I probably would test it right
away. For now we can just leave
it in here. That's going to be
great for getting this image
here. But we don't want just an
image, right? We were going to
need that metadata. We need this
to be a JSON object, not just an
image URL like this, we need
stick this image, this base 64
encoded image into this image
field of our JSON. So how do we
actually do this? Well, what we
can do is we know that our ERC
721 code comes with a token URI,
and it's that token URI that
points to this, which tells us
what our code is going to look
like. So what we can do is we
can actually base 64 encode our
JSON as well, to turn into a
JSON token URI. So we basically
four encoded this image to get
this, we're going to stick this
URL into our JSON. And then
we're going to base 64 encode
our JSON, and that's going to be
the URI that our token uses. So
we have our function, token URI,
right. And this takes a un 256
token ID, we'll say it's going
to be a public view, public view
override, and it returns a
string memory. So we're going to
override the token URI function
of the ERC 721 to whatever we
want it to be. And here we're
going to encode some JSON text
that we give our contract into a
base 64 based JSON token URI
just to get started we'll do a
require underscore exists. Token
ID, and then I'm just gonna say
your I query for non existent
token. And yeah, this price
should be an if not exists,
Revert with an error. However,
we're just going to go like
this. And this exists function
comes in my ear C 721. So we're
going to do same thing here. So
we're gonna say require this
token, a D exists. And again, we
can 100 percent. And probably should
make this an IF EXISTS token,
ID, you know, now what we want
to do is we want to figure out
how to make this token URI
return a base 64 encoded version
of this JSON. So first, we know
how to how to concatenate a
string, right, so that's gonna
be the first thing that we're
going to do. So we'll do API dot
and code packed. And we're going
to encode ourselves the JSON on
chain, we're going to use single
quotes here, because inside of
this API and code packed, we're
going to use double quotes in
here is where we're going to add
our JSON. So we'll give a name,
right, so the first piece of
metadata needs to be a name. So
we'll give it a name. And we'll
put a comma here. And we'll say
the name of this NF T is going
to be the name we get from, we
have a name function, which
returns the name. So we're gonna
say the name is going to be the
name. And we're gonna just
concatenate all this stuff, name
right there. We're gonna
continue on with the JSON. So we
put a little quote here, and a
little quote here. So we
encapsulate this name in quotes,
right? Because remember, we're,
we're concatenating, this big
string that we're making here,
we'll do a comma, we'll say,
description, we'll do another
quote. And this time, we're just
going to put the description
ourselves, and we'll say, and
NFT, that changes, based on the
chain link feed, we'll put an
end quote here and a comma, and
we'll put a comma outside the
quote, down here, we'll say,
attributes.
We'll just say, trait type, it's
going to be coolness. Comma,
value, me 100. Boom, to a comma
to image. We'll put a comma out
here. And this is where we're
going to put our image URI,
image URI, which we're going to
have to get from somewhere. So
for now, I'm just gonna say,
string.
Memory image URI equals i,
right, which clearly isn't an
image arrived. But just to make
this format and stuff, we'll
we'll put this there. This is
where we're going to put that
image URI that we get from SVG
to image URI. And then that's
it. I mean, close off our JSON,
though. So doing ABI dot encode
pack is going to concatenate
this all together. So this is
basically going to be a string
that looks like this. Great. But
how do we turn this into a base
64 encoded token you arrive so
that other people can read it is
we're going to typecast this
whole thing to bytes. And then
now that this whole thing is in
bytes, we can do exactly what we
did with the SVG above is now we
can base 64 encoded. So we'll do
base 64, dot ENCODE. And then
we'll just put another pair of
parentheses around this save and
auto formatted. And this here is
going to give us this second
line, right, it's going to give
us all of this bit, but it's not
going to give us this first bit,
right. So we just need to append
to this first bit now. And we
should be good to go. For basics
before data image SVG plus XML
basics, the form, this is the
prefix for images for SVG
images, right? We use that above
because that's the prefix for
SVG images. The prefix for base
64. Jason is going to be it's
going to be data application
JSON base 64. So we're going to
do it like this instead. Now the
ERC 721 has something called a
base URI that we're going to
override and that we're going to
use. So we're gonna say function
underscore base URI. This will
be internal pure. And we're
going to override the one that
ERC 721 has. And this is going
to returns a string memory. And
we're just going to return this
bit right here. And now we can
use this base URI. to append,
right, we're going to append
this first part to our base 64
encoded JSON. So in order to
append them, once again, we'll
do ABI dot ENCODE, packed. And
then we'll put this down here.
And we'll say, we're going to,
we're going to concatenate base
URI to this massive thing that
we just created. And then we
save and we ought to format the
now this is obviously a bytes
object, and we want it to be a
string. So then all we got to do
is typecast it as a string, but
another prints see down here,
and then we can actually just
return this, but basically what
we're doing is we're creating a
JSON string, we encode it in
bytes, that way we can encode it
in base 64. Once we have encoded
in base 64, which is going to
look like this second string,
it's gonna look like here out,
we then just append this initial
part. But for JSON objects, it's
data application JSON. We we
append that we do API dot encode
packed, and then cast it to
string and then boom, we now
have a token URI. That'll look
something like this. And then
all we have to do is update our
image URI with what we get from
our function appear, and then
we'll be good to go. So let's
finish this out. Let's do this.
So in our constructor, we're
passing a low SVG and a high
SVG. And what are these low SVG
is in these high SVG as well,
basically saying, when the price
of this asset is too low, show a
frown. And when the price of the
asset is high, show a smiley
face. So we're gonna give it
this frown, SVG, and this happy
SVG as input parameters, low CG
and high SVG, we probably want
to save those. But we don't
necessarily want to save them in
like their SVG format. So we
just want to store the image
URI, right, we will just want to
store this string up here
instead of the actual SVG. So
right in our constructor, we can
do I underscore low image URI
equals, and we have this SVG to
image your eye function, where
we can pass the low SVG. And
then we can do the same thing
for the high image URI. So now,
SVG image URI is going to return
something that looks like this.
And we're going to store just
this string this image URI on
chain. Now that we have the two
of those, we can use that down
below. In our token, Uri
function, when somebody calls
token, your I have token ID
zero, we're going to stick into
our JSON, either the low image
or I or the high image arrive.
And we're actually going to base
that off of the channeling price
feed. So how do we do that?
Well,
we've already worked with
channeling price feeds before so
let's go ahead and add it. So
yarn add dash dash dev at chain
link slash contracts. Once
that's done at the top, we can
do import at chain link slash
contracts, slash SRC slash V
0.8, slash interfaces, slash ag
reg gate, Tor V three interface,
that soul like so. And then down
here, let's comment this out.
For now, we're going to want to
call a price feed to figure out
what the price is and then show
the high image or the low image
based off that. So in order to
get a price feed in our
constructor, let's just add
another price feed address,
street address. And then we'll
make another variable. We'll do
aggregate Tor v3 interface.
Internal, immutable, I
underscore price feed. And we'll
say in our constructor, I price
feed equals aggregate Tor v3
interface at price feed,
address. And then what we can do
down here, the old bunch of
commas in here into 256 Price
comma, comma comma equals i
price feed that latest round
data. And what we can do is we
can say if price is greater than
or equal to some value, then
show one image dry otherwise,
show another one. So we can say
String memory, image URI equals
s underscore low image URI. And
then if the price is higher than
some value, well greater than
the image URI we're going to use
is going to be there's gonna be
AI is going to equal the high
image URI. And then we have
image right down here. So all we
got to do is figure out the
price. So we can make, and in
our mind, we'll let the mentors
choose the value that they want
to use. So we can say, into 256,
I value and we'll assign each
NFT, their own high value. So
we'll need to create like a
little mapping up top, we'll
say, mapping, you went to 56.
Two, you went to 56. Let's just
make this public for the heck of
it public s underscore token ID
to high value. And we'll say
that when they meant an NF T
will do s token ID to high
value, s underscore token
counter. We'll set that equal to
high value. So when they meant
they choose the high value that
they want. And then down here
we'll say if the price is
greater than or equal to the
high value of the token ID, then
we'll use the high one.
Otherwise, we'll just use the
low one. Oops, and this needs to
be you into videos x two into
256. Excuse me, since we want to
be able to compare them pretty
equally. And boom, our contract
looks really good. Now the only
thing we'd want to add in here
is probably an event. So we
probably want to emit an event
in time we met to one of these
NF T's. So we might do event
created NF T, will say you went
to 56 indexed token ID comma int
256. I value like so. And then
when we met this NFT, will do
emit create n t, s underscore
token counter, comma, I value.
And then it's best practice to
to have to update our token
counter before we actually do
the minting. So we'll do that as
well. Okay, there's a ton of
code here. And like I said, we
definitely would not have
written all that code without
having compiled to run some
tests first, but we decided we
want to just write it all right
off first. So and I did some
misspellings. Let's just make
sure everything compiles here.
Awesome. Everything's compiled
here. As you already know, a
couple things that we're going
to need to do to test this out.
First thing we're gonna need to
do is write our deploy function,
we've got our basic NFT, we've
got our random and f t, both of
these hosted on IPFS. Now we're
going to do a dynamic NFT that's
hosted 100 percent on chain, and it
changes based off the price of
an asset. So let's do this. Oh,
three, deploy dynamic, SVG
nft.js. We are no, we're gonna
need a little bit of
boilerplate. So let's go to our
basic NFT. And we'll just grab
all this the first seven lines
or so. And we'll just paste it
in here. What do we need for our
constructor? Well, we
need a price feed address, a low
SVG and a highest CG. Okay, so
let's get all of those. So price
feed address is something we've
already done before. And we can
add that into our helper
Hardhead config. And we'll do
one and a foreign local, we're
going to use what we're going to
use a mock. And if we're on
Rinkeby, or an actual network,
we're going to use an actual
address. So let's go ahead to
dark side chain that link will
grab a price feed address, the M
Aetherium. data feeds will go to
rank B, rank B and let's just
use eath USD copy that will make
a new entry eath USD price feed
like so. And for localhost,
we're good. So since we know for
localhost, we're going to need
to do a mock. Let's see if we
have a price feed mock. Okay,
now we don't, we're gonna need a
mock v3 aggregator dot soul. I
just copied pasted mine. If you
want, you can just go right to
the to a repo here. Or you can
copy from a previous section,
just a reminder heart at f and f
t FCC contracts asked moc v3
aggregator and this is using
point 06 of solidity. So we're
going to want to make sure that
in our hard hat dot config, we
have at least one 0.6 version,
which we do so we're good there.
That means in our deploy mocks,
we're going to want to add So
initial price will be 2000
decimals will be a team. So now
we've waited to deploy mocks for
that price feed. So we're gonna
say const chain ID equals
network dot config dot chain Id
do if development chains dot
includes network dot name, and
the more we need to import
development chains looks like
where did say const eth USD
akregator equals we'll get that
price feed equals awaits ethers
dot get contract Mark v3 Air
gate tour, and then we'll up
here we'll do let eath USD price
feed address eath USD price feed
address equals eath USD
aggregate tore that address else
will say the eath USD price feed
address is going to be equal to
what we find in the network
config. Network config. Chain ID
dot eth USD price. Okay, so we
have the eth USD price feed
rate. Now we need the lowest VG
and the high SVG. So we're going
to create a new folder in our
images folder. So we go CD
images, MK dir dynamic NF t. And
now we'll have two folders in
here dynamic which is empty and
random, which has all the random
stuff. If you want to use your
own SVGs for this, you
absolutely can. But if you want
to just come to my images file
and then save these images as so
just come right click Save image
as. Save them. and then drag and
drop them into your images files
here, you can absolutely do
that. So now that we have those,
we want to go ahead and read
those into our script here.
We'll say const, low SVG equals
a weight. And we're going to use
Fs again. So we're gonna do
const Fs equals require Fs, or
do await Fs dot read file sync,
we're going to read in this
file, which for me, it's at dot
slash images slash dynamic NF T
slash brown dot SVG. And we're
using encoding of UTF eight. And
then we'll say const. Hi, SVG
equals await Fs dot read file
sync. Copy this whole thing,
because we're using the same
stuff. This one's going to be
happy about SVG. And that's it.
So when price is good, we're
gonna do happiness, SVG, when
price is bad, we're gonna do
frown at SVG. Now, let's go
ahead and let's deploy this
contract. So we'll say arguments
or args equals, it's gonna be
the price feed address, low SVG,
and then high SVG. And we'll say
const, dynamic S, G and F T
equals await, deploy dynamic SVG
and f t, comma little bracket
here, from Deployer.
args, args log true. And the
weights confirmations, it's
going to be network dot config,
that block confirmations, or one
will do some logging, I will do
log to do that. But Larry, do
some verification, I'm actually
just going to copy paste that
from our last script, because
it's going to be exactly the
same copy paste. But instead of
random IPFS, it's going to be
dynamic SVG and f t. The rest of
this looks good. And that's just
about it. So we'll do module,
exports dot tags, equals and
we'll do all dynamic. SVG. And
we'll do main. Oh, okay. Let's
try to see if our deploy script
that we just created works. To
do h h, or yarn hardhat deployed
dash dash tags, die Namic SVG,
that makes sense, because we
didn't deploy the mocks. So
we'll do tags, dynamic SVGs. And
then also the mocks. Local
network detected play marks, we
deploy the marks, deploying
dynamic SVG, awesome. You know
what comes next? You Gosh, darn
right, it's time for some tests.
Now, once again, I'm going to
encourage you to pause the video
now and try to write your own
test for this test for this
section actually can be a little
bit tricky. Since we are going
to be manipulating the price of
our mock aggregator, we are
checking for these long strings,
and such. So be sure to use the
GitHub repository associated
with this lesson, in case you
get lost. Now, I want to show
you what this looks like on a
marketplace, like OpenCL. So we
are going to deploy this to rink
B. Now keep in mind test that
can be slow. So you might want
to be patient here. And you
don't even have to do it if you
don't want to. But it is kind of
nice to see. Okay, that's what
it really looks like. And you
can go to the contract on chain
once it's verified. And you can
read the token URI and
everything. And it's pretty fun.
So let's just add one more bit
to our deploy folder. Let's add
a mint script that just emits an
NF T for each one of these
contracts. So we're going to
create no for mint.js. And we're
just going to have each one of
these contracts mint NFT. Let's
go ahead and do this. So in
here, we'll do const ethers
network equals require arhat.
And then I'm going to do a
little copy paste in. I'm just
going to copy this part because
I know I'm going to need that.
We are going to need a deploy
but we're not going to need to
deploy. So I'll grab get named
accounts, get named accounts,
it's going to come right from
there. So we have a Deployer.
Our deployer is just gonna be
used to mint them. First we'll
mint the basic NF t. So we'll
say const basic NF t equals wait
ethers dot get contract, basic N
ft, and we'll connect the
deployer to it. And then we'll
say const basic mint and if T or
basic mint, TX equals await
basic NF T dot mint NF t. And
then we'll do a weight basic
mint, TX dot weight one and then
we'll do a little console dot
log base Again, T index zero has
token URI, we'll put in a little
await basic NF T dot token URI
of zero. That's it for the basic
entity. Now we'll do our random
IPFS and empty. So we'll say
const, random IPFS NF t equals
await ethers dot get contract,
random IPFS and f t, connected
to the Deployer. This one, we
need a mint fee. So we'll say
const, mint V equals await
random IPFS NF T dot get mint
fee. And then we'll do the mint.
So we'll say const, random IPFS
and ft mint, TX equals await,
random IPFS and F T dot request
and F team. And for this one, we
need to pass a value, which is
going to be the mint v.to
string. Now for this one, just
like what we saw in our tests,
we're going to have to do this
await new promise again, right,
because we need to wait for it
to return need to listen for
those events, we probably should
set up the listener first. So
let's actually set up the
listener first. So we're going
to do await new promise, and
we're gonna do async function.
And we're going to do resolve
reject. In here, we're gonna use
that, that fun little arrow
syntax in here.
And now since we're in this
function here, we actually set
the timeout resolve like this,
which means we have five minutes
to time this out, you might want
to bump this up even more five
minutes might not be enough,
this is gonna be 300
milliseconds here, we're gonna
do that once again. So we'll say
random IPFS and ft dot once.
Once we get that NFT minted
event, we're going to run an
async function, we're just gonna
do resolve. And inside here is
where we can actually put,
actually requesting the NFT. But
below our listener, right, so in
there, and then we can say if
developments chains, that
includes network dot name. So
let's just make sure we import
those development chains and
network or affect them and
chains that includes network dot
name. So we're on a test net,
this is where we go ahead and we
pretend to be those mocks. So
we'll say const Request ID
equals random IPFS. Oh,
actually, we're going to need to
do const random IPFS and ft min
TX receipt equals await on IPFS
and empty minted TX dot weight
one. So we're gonna need to get
the receipt. And from the
receipt, we can get the request
ID. That events one dot args dot
request id.to string. And then
we can do const VRF. coordinator
V to mock equals await ethers
dot get contract, the RF
coordinate for V to mock,
connect this to the Deployer.
And then we'll do a wait the RF
corded and a Tor V to mock that
fulfill random words with
Request ID, random IPFS. And if
T dot address, we can do console
dot log random IPFS and have T
index zero token URI to await
random IP. That's NF T dot token
URI of zero. Finally, we can do
our dynamic SVG, NF t. So we can
say const, high high value
equals ethers.utils.do parse
ether here. So we'll say
4000 $4,000 will be the high
value. We'll say const. Dynamic
SVG and f t equals await ethers
dot get contract, dynamic. SVG
and a T will connect it to the
deployer say const by Namic, s,
B, G, and f t mint, TX equals
await dynamic SVG and F T dot
mint and f t i value to string
then we'll just do wait. This
stat wait one. And finally
console dot log dynamic. SVG NFT
index zero token URI is going to
be a weight dynamic. SVG and ft
dot token URI of zero. Okay, I
think that looks good. Let's try
this on a local network. So
we'll do yarn hard hat deploy.
And we'll run all those scripts
It looks like everything worked.
So we have random, basic NFT
index zero has a token year, I
have this IPFS thing, random
IPFS NFT. index zero has this
thing. And then our SVG has this
giant monstrosity, okay,
perfect. And then we can even
check, right, we can even grab
this IPFS hash, we go to our
IPFS node, or if you installed
IPFS in your browser, or you're
working with Brave, we can just
pop it right into our browsers
and see what it looks like.
Right. And then if I zoom in,
and adorable St. Bernard, with
the image of the St. Bernard,
looking like that, this one's
also gonna be St. Bernard. And
then of course, are SVG, which
we can also copy, paste, and
boom, that looks great. And then
we can copy the image. And it's
a frowny face or shad. But
Awesome. Okay, so it's working
locally for us. Now, let's go
ahead and try to make this work
on an actual test net. So
hopefully, our helper hard hat
config is set up correctly. And
there's enough stuff in here
where we need to make sure that
we have a subscription ID,
right, we're going to need to
make sure we have a subscription
ID. And we shouldn't call the
mint function, right, because
we're going to need to add our
consumer to the VRF. Before we
can actually meant so let me
let's add some tags to our meant
here. So we'll do module dot
exports, dot tags equals, and
we'll say all comma meant a
while ago, I said okay, let's
add a main tag. Now we're coming
around to why we added this main
tag here. So what we want to do
is want to deploy all of these
contracts. But before we finally
meant for our IPFS one, we need
to add that contract to our
consumer, here's what we're
gonna do, we're gonna run yarn,
Hardhead, deploy dash dash
network Rinkeby dash dash tags
main. Now, this won't meant any
of our NF T's, okay, won't mean
to any of our NF T's, it'll just
deploy those contracts might
just sit around and wait a
little bit for these to actually
deploy. So this is a great time
to go take a break, maybe go
take a walk, get a sip of water,
get a cup of coffee, whatever
you want to do. Yeah, once
everything is deployed, then we
can go to V or F dot chain dot
link, we're already connected
here, we used our subscription.
And then we would just add our
IPFS consumer in here. And we'd
be good to go. And All right,
once everything goes through,
and we have all three of our
transactions on the blockchain,
we can go ahead, we can grab our
random IPFS NF T, we'll grab
that address, we'll come back
over to V or F dot chain dot
link slash rink D, we'll go to
our subscription ID, and we'll
add a new consumer will add that
contract address. So we'll go
ahead and approve and Metamask.
And once this goes through, we
can finish running the mint part
of our deploy folder. Once it's
confirmed, we can close maybe we
can do a little refresh, we
should see our new address added
as a subscription here. Now that
we've added that we can mint one
NF T from each one of these
contracts are in hard hats,
deploy dash dash tags meant dash
dash network Rinkeby. And we'll
have to wait a little bit for
this too. Okay, now that we have
them all minted, we should get a
little output like this. Right?
Basic NF t zero has token URI
here. Basic random IPFS NF T has
token your eye here. And then
our SVG has this as a token
year, right. So what can we do
now? Well, let me go grab, I'll
grab my wallet address and stick
it into Rinkeby ether scan. And
we can see we called mint
request and mint again. And we
created three contracts, right,
we created our basic NFT, our
random IPFS NFT and our dynamic
SVG NFT. What we can do now is
we can grab, we can copy the
address of our contract. And we
can go to test nets that open
see that i Oh,
and we can put that address in
the bar here in the search bar
here. Now this part is
incredibly, incredibly variable.
Okay, open C can be really slow.
And it can take open see up to a
couple of hours to register that
a contract has been deployed to
a test net. So if it doesn't
show up right away, don't be
discouraged. Don't let it drag
you down. But if it does, you
should be able to click on your
collection and see the NFT is
actually here. I'm going to grab
our random IPFS NFT. Let's grab
that contract address. I'm going
to grab that test net site open
c.io. Paste that address in
there. And what do you know we
do indeed see, random IPFS and f
t, right and I've deployed a
couple of them. So this one's v
two, and we have our adorable
Shiva in you right here. So this
is what it looks like an open C
now we can 100 percent verify that our
code is good even if it doesn't
show up on Open. See. If we go
to the contract we go to read
contract. And then we go to
token URI punch and zero here. A
query, grabbed this, stick it
into our browsers, the JSON
looks good. So let's grab the
image URI. Paste that in. And if
we can see this here, that means
that our code is good. And you
have successfully deployed a
number of FFTs to the
blockchain. We have learned a
massive amount in this course,
this is definitely one of the
most jam packed one. And it's
all about art. Right? Isn't that
crazy? Let's do a quick
refresher of this entire course
here. So first off, we learned
the basics of an NF T with our
basic NF T dot Sol, we learn
that these NF T's are based off
of the ERC 721 standard. And
that just means they have
functions like name, token, Uri,
etc. We learned that NF T's use
this token URI to tell us what
the token actually looks like a
token, your eye will look
something like this, it's going
to be a name a description, it's
going to have an image URL,
which points to a different
location for what the NFT
actually looks like. It'll have
stuff like attributes, it can
have stuff like attributes, and
a few other tags. This is known
as the metadata of the NFT. And
this tells us about the NFT. We
can also have all that metadata
on chain, of course, to
customize it on chain, and make
it look and grow and change and
be interactive on chain, we
learned more about IPFS, we
actually wrote a script called
upload to pinjarra.js, where we
can actually programmatically
upload images and files to
another IPFS pinning service for
us, we can of course, always use
our own IPFS nodes if we want.
Now this token URI can really be
anything. And we hosted it on
IPFS for our basic NFT and for
our random NFT. But for our
dynamic NFT, we actually hosted
the token, you're right 100 percent On
chain, so we didn't use IPFS.
And we made this dynamic where
the token URI actually changes
based off of the price of a
changeling price feed in our
random IPFS NFT, we gave our NFT
a chance we gave different
rarities to the different dogs
so that we could create
programmatically rare NF TS
where our pug is super rare. Our
Shiva is sort of rare, and our
St. Bernard is pretty common. So
the fact that we got to ship it
in you was awesome. We did some
amazing deployments, we wrote
some tests. Not only that, but
we learned a lot about
transactions, and how we can
actually add whatever data we
want to this data section. And a
little bit more about what our
transactions look like, and how
we can actually use functions,
selectors and function
signatures to be able to call
anything, right and we learn
more about ABI dot encoding, and
encoding packed and all this
binary stuff if you want it to
go deep into that. So this was
an absolutely JAM PACKED
session. And you should be
incredibly proud of yourself,
especially with your little
puppy that you can see on open
sea or you can see directly on
ether scan, or you can just look
at it and IPFS and be really
proud of what you've done. But
with that being said, huge
congratulations on making this
far. Definitely definitely
definitely take a break here,
and we'll see you in the next
one.
Okay, now we have less than
fifth team, which is going to be
our next JS NFT marketplace. And
if you finish this lesson, you
are a web three full stack
monster, this is going to be our
most complicated front end using
the web three stack and using a
lot of really advanced web
three, and blockchain tools. So
get really excited because we
are going to learn a ton in this
lesson. Now there are actually
three different repos associated
with this lesson. The first one
is going to be our typical hard
hat project. For the back end,
after the hard hat project, we
actually have two repos both are
going to be our front end repos,
and they're going to be slightly
different. In this project,
we're going to learn more about
how events are so important and
why events are so important,
especially for off chain
services. And so we're actually
going to look at two different
ways to work with them, one
using the mirallas, or a
centralized database, and then
one using the graph. And the
reason that I want to show both
of these is that oftentimes,
when people are looking to scale
the projects, when people are
looking to get things done
really quickly, taking a more
centralized approach can often
be a little quicker, and you can
sometimes add more functionality
to your website. And there's
still a lot of protocols that
have decentralized backends. And
centralized front ends. One such
example, is open sea, open sea,
for example, has the ability to
actually like different and fts.
Now, this isn't something that
we would actually want to spend
any gas on. But it is something
that we're gonna have to store
in some type of database
somewhere, so that people have
the ability to do that. So I
want to show you this optional
first way to build these front
ends, since all of our logic is
still going to be 100 percent. On
chain, the front end matters a
little bit less, because anybody
can still interact with the
contracts that we build on
chain. Now in web three, we
don't want to stay there.
However, getting an MVP done
getting a minimal viable project
done is really, really
important. So using a
centralized server, like
Morales, or centralized project
can make us much quicker. In
fact, we have been using
centralized services, like
alchemy, kind of throughout this
whole project. But of course, I
also want to show you the
decentralized way to make your
front end. So after we work with
Morales, we're also going to
show you how to use the graph
then for to do all this event
indexing. Now the graph is going
to be the decentralized way we
can make our front end and work
with these events. And the graph
also comes with its own graph
repo. So we'll learn all about
that once we get to the front
end section. But let me show you
what we're going to build
because it is really cool. Now
that we've learned a ton about
how to make NF T's what they
are, we're going to make our own
NFT marketplace. And like I
said, this is really going to be
our deep dive into all these
amazing front end tools. So
here's what our front end is
gonna look like. But what we can
do is we can connect with our
little connect button, we hit
Metamask Metamask pops up, we'll
go ahead and connect. And now
that we're connected, we can see
the different entities in here.
And if we're on an address
that's owned by us, it will say
owned by you. And if we switch
addresses, or UI will go ahead
and update, connect there. And
now we're owned by a different
address. Now, if it's owned by
us, we get this little hover
that says Update listing. And
right now it's worth 0.18.
That's what it's listed for on
our marketplace. If it's owned
by us, and we click it, we can
update it to a different price.
Let's update it to 50 eath, or
whatever your layer one currency
is, we'll just say new listing
price, we'll go ahead and
confirm. And I'll say listing
updated, please refresh, and
what we can do them. And we'll
mine some blocks on the back
end, and boom, now we see that
it's worth 50 here. Now if we
switch to a different account,
now we can see owned by blah,
blah, blah, and the hovered now
says by me, if his selected as a
different user, I'm gonna get
this transaction to actually buy
it. Now go ahead and confirm
that I'm gonna buy it, I get a
little pop up. This is item
bought successfully. Now if I do
a little refresh, we'll now see
that that NFT is gone from the
marketplace, since we bought it
right, it's no longer available
to be sold. Now what we can do
then is we can come over to sell
NF Ts and at the bottom, we'll
see a withdraw proceeds. So
whenever somebody buys an NF T,
the NFT marketplace actually
keeps the proceeds that actually
keeps the result of the sale. So
if we switch back to our address
that had the NF T listed, we can
now see Withdraw 50 proceeds
because we know that we have 50
eath, because we just bought
that for 50. So if we hit
withdraw, Metamask is gonna pop
up, we can go ahead and confirm,
wait a little bit as transaction
populates, and boom once it goes
through, we'll see now we have
zero proceeds. Right, we
withdrew everything from here.
So what we can do now, is we can
relist that NFT. So if we come
back, let's go back to the one
who just bought that NF t. If we
know the address and the token
ID of the NF t and we own it, we
can go ahead and relist it,
because we can place the address
in here with the token ID Give
us some sort of price, we'll
submit, we'll approve giving the
NFT marketplace access to our
NFT to our little doggie. And
then we'll go ahead and actually
send the transaction to actually
list the NFT on a marketplace
that we get NFT listed
successfully. After we remove
some blocks in the back end, we
can go back to the front end.
And we now see, it's owned by
us, instead of the original
owner, right and set for 10
ether. And then we can of
course, switch back to a
different user, and we can have
them actually buy. So this is
going to be a NFT marketplace
that's completely decentralized,
we are going to learn a ton
about front end a ton about
indexing a ton about events, and
why they are so powerful. And
I'm really excited for you for
this one. Because if you get
through this one, you will have
so many tools at your fingertips
for working with the blockchain.
Are you ready, let's jump in.
Let's build the contracts first,
and then we'll build the front
end. Let's do this. Now this
project is going to be based off
the Arteon project, which is a
completely open source
decentralized smart contract NFT
marketplace, I'll leave a link
to it in the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
ours of course, is going to be a
minimalistic version of this.
So we're in our VS code pre
normal. And we're going to
create a new folder here called
hard hat. And if T marketplace,
FCC, oops, MK dir, like them,
we're gonna cd into it. And then
open this up and its own VS
code. Once again, you can use
code period, or file open
folder, and open this folder.
Once we get in here, we're going
to do all of our normal stuff
that we've been doing throughout
the course. And once again, if
you want to copy paste over your
package, JSON, if you want to
copy paste in the modules,
whatever you want to do, feel
free to do so I'm gonna go ahead
actually, this repo here, we're
gonna scroll up and just grab
once again, this line from less
than nine. And just run that I
know I'm gonna be using prettier
so I'm just gonna go ahead and
copy paste those two prettier
files over prettier ignore and
prettier RC going to be using
them again, for linting. With
solidity we're going to use Sol
hint dot JSON. So we're going to
grab that dot soul hint dot
JSON. And the dots will hint dot
ignore. I'm also going to grab
the hard hat dot config dot j s
because we're going to be using
a really, really similar setup.
And this hard hat dot config dot
j s. It's got waffle in it,
ether scan, hard hat deploy
coverage gas reporter sizer and
Dottie and v dot config, we're
going to bring over our Dotty
and V. And we're also gonna
bring over our utils folder as
well. Right, so a lot of that
boilerplate we're gonna bring on
over. And now just like that,
since we have the hard hat dot
config dot j s in here, if we
run yarn, hard hat, right now,
yarn hard hat will actually see
we get the output like this. So
let's go ahead. And before we
actually write our contracts,
let's go ahead and write a
little doc saying what our
contract is even going to do,
what do we want this to do?
We're going to create a
decentralized NFT marketplace.
So what does that mean? What
will we probably need? Well,
we'll probably need some type of
list item function, because
we'll want to list NF T's and
this will be to list NF t's on
the marketplace, we'll need some
type of buy item to buy the NF
T's. And then we'll probably
need maybe like a cancel listing
or cancel item, if you no longer
want to sell it, maybe an update
listing, update price. And then
maybe a withdraw proceeds to
withdraw payment or my bot and
fts. So when somebody buys an
NFT, I'm gonna have to withdraw
it from the contract since the
contract is going to be the one
to actually hold those funds.
That looks pretty good to me.
Let's go ahead and start
building this. So let's create a
new folder, contracts. And let's
jump into this. So we'll create
a new file NFT marketplace.
That's all. So let's get our
boilerplate. spdx pragma,
solidity, carrot zero, point,
8.7, contract and ft.
Marketplace, boom. If we're
doing this, right, h h compile
or yarn Hardhead to compile or
MPX, art, hit, compile, boom,
things are looking good. So if
we go back to our readme, we can
grab these here, even stick them
in as like a little comment for
us to kind of reference later
on. Let's start with listing the
items. How are we going to keep
track of listing people's items.
And once again, remember, when
I'm usually coding this, I'm
going back and forth between
writing tests and writing the
actual code. We're just going to
write all the solidity in one
chunk, and then go write the
tests. So we're going to say,
these are going to be our main
functions. I'm going to start
with function list item. And we
are going to make this one look
really, really good. So we're
going to do natspec. And
everything, this is going to
need to be an external function,
right, we're probably not going
to want any of our internal
functions calling list item,
it's going to be called by
external projects or external
accounts are probably going to
need an address and ft address,
write the address of the NFT,
contract a un 256 token ID, the
ID of the token ID of the
contract that we're going to
use. And then we're going to
want to set a un 256 price. So
first off, we're probably going
to want the price to be greater
than zero. So maybe we'll put in
like a little if or require
statement here, we'll say if
price is less than or equal to
zero, then we'll go ahead and
revert with a price must be
above zero error. And then of
course, we'll prepend it with
the name of the contract into
underscores. And then at the
top, the error price must be
above zero. Now in order for us
to list it, we could actually do
this one of two ways we could
one, we could send the NFT to
the contract, this would require
us doing like a transfer, right,
we could have got the contract
hold the NFT. Now we could do
this, but this is going to be
kind of gas expensive for
someone to actually list on f t.
And we can have the owner of the
NFT be our NFT marketplace, we
could 100 percent do that. The issue
with this, though is that the
marketplace will then own the
NFT. And the user won't be able
to say like, Hey, I own this
NFT, it's in the marketplace,
they technically would be able
to but they would have to
withdraw it, we might do this a
slightly different way where we
can say owners can still hold
their NFT and give the
marketplace approval to sell the
NFT for them. Now, of course the
owners of the entity could
withdraw approval at any time
and the marketplace wouldn't be
able to sell it anymore.
However, this would be really
easy for people to actually
read, they would all they would
have to do is read like is
approved for marketplace. And
they can actually see if the
item was really listed or not.
So we're gonna go ahead and
write it this second way,
because that's what Ardian does.
And this is the least intrusive
way to have this marketplace,
right? People still will have
ownership of their NF Ts, and
the marketplace will just have
approval to actually swap and
sell their NF T once the prices
are met. So since we want to
make sure the marketplace has
approval, let's make sure the
marketplace has approval. So we
can call we can call this get
approved function on that token
ID to make sure that the
marketplace is approved to work
with the NFT. To do this, we're
going to need the AI ERC 720
interface and we can actually
grab that from open Zeppelin.
Right and this interface will
wrap around an address and then
we can call get approved on that
address. So we'll do import at
open Zeppelin slash contracts
slash token slash ERC 721 slash
I ERC 721 dot Sol. And since
we're doing an import from open
Zeppelin, we'll do yarn add dash
dash Dev, add open Zeppelin now
that we have this interface in
here, what we can do is we'll
say I ERC 721 NF t equals IRC
721 wrapped around this NF T
address that we're passing in.
And we'll say if NF T dot get
approved of the token ID that
we're trying to list does not
equal address this. So if we are
not approved, then we'll revert
not approved or market place.
And then we'll of course we'll
want to do prepend it with NFT
marketplace into underscores. So
error like this, Bada bing bada
boom, now that we've gotten a
little bit of that out of the
way, we're probably going to
want to have some type of data
structure to list all these NF
T's. And typically we get to
Okay, do we want to use an
array? Or do we want to use a
mapping? What do you think?
Before we continue? Let's pause
for a second, do you think it
makes more sense to put these NF
T's and an array or an A
mapping? And when you're
thinking about this, try to
think about, okay, well, people
are gonna have to buy these and
sell these, what makes more
sense, think about this for a
second, maybe pause it and write
in a comment here, what you
think an array or a mapping is
better. Now, if you said
mapping, I would agree with you.
You couldn't do an array and you
wouldn't necessarily be wrong,
but it's not the way that I
would go about that for an
array. Anytime someone wants to
buy an item, we're gonna have to
traverse through the array,
we're gonna have to make this
massive dynamic array. And that
might get a little bit dicey as
that array gets really, really
big. So we're gonna go ahead and
make this a mapping. And this is
probably going to be a global
variable or a state variable. So
up at the top, let's go ahead
and create this mapping, it's
going to be a mapping of
addresses of NFT addresses.
Right? So it's going to be the
NFT contract address mapped to
the NFT, token ID mapped to some
type of listing. So we'll say, a
mapping of address to a mapping
of UNT 256. to, well, what do we
want here? Well, we want we want
the price, right? So is that
another you went up to six. But
we also want, we also want to
keep track of the sellers, we
know who to send money to. So we
could make two mappings or we
just create a new type of type
listing, let's go ahead and do
that. We'll comment this out for
now. And so at the top, since
this is going to be a type
where, say, struct listing, and
in here, we're going to do a
utility six, the price of the NF
t, and then address the seller
of the NF team. And now that we
have that new typing, we can
uncomment this, we can say NFT,
contract address map to the NFT
token ID mapped to the listing,
and we'll make this a private
variable called S underscore
listings. Now back down in our
list item function, we're going
to update that s listing
mapping. So we're gonna say s
listing of NF T address, right,
the address of the NF T at the
token ID is going to equal we're
gonna create a listing of the
price. And then who, well the
seller is going to be message
that sender, right? So message
dot sender, they're the one
who's actually listing the item.
And since we're updating a
mapping here, what's the best
practice for update mappings,
you guessed it, we need to emit
an event and especially for this
project, you're gonna see why
emitting events, for at least
this project, this is so
helpful. So we're gonna go ahead
and emit an item listed event,
which we're going to create in
just a second. And we'll give
the message that sender, the NFT
address, the token ID, and the
price item listed. And then up
at the top, of course, but below
our structure, we're gonna say
event item listed will do an
address indexed seller
address indexed NFT, address,
address indexed token ID, and
then a un 256 price. Sorry, this
needs to be a un 256 token ID,
you int 56. This looks pretty
good to us. However, we probably
want to make sure we only list
and FTEs that haven't already
been listed. So we can add like
an if then in here. And this is
kind of where preference comes
in a little bit. But I'm
actually going to create a
modifier called not listed. So
we make sure we don't relist,
and if T's that are already
listed above our main functions,
or do like a little indicator
modifier not listed. This is
gonna take an an address NFT
address, a un 256 token ID and
an address owner. And what we're
going to say is we're going to
check, we're going to make a new
listing memory listing equals s
underscore listings of NFT
address token ID. Now we're
gonna say if listing dot price
is greater than zero, we're
gonna go ahead and revert with
already passing the NFT address
and a token ID. And of course,
we're going to prepend this with
NFT marketplace. And at the top,
we do error ft marketplace
already listed, like so. And
then we're going to put a little
underscore right underneath and
then up here, we'll do address
and if the address you went to
56. Okay, ID. So this modifier
looks pretty good. Let's just
make sure it's actually going to
compile we'll do yarn Hardhead
compile or hh compile. Great.
That looks good. We'll add this
modifier to our list item
function will do NFT address,
token ID message dot sender.
Cool. What else should we check
for here? Well, we should also
check that the NF T that's being
listed is owned by message dot
sender. This way only the owners
of the NF T can actually listed
here so let's go ahead and we'll
add a is owner modifier modifier
is owner NFT address token ID
spender you into 256 here and an
address spender I ERC 721 NF t
equals IRC 721 And if the
address address owner equals NF
T dot owner a Have a token ID.
And then we'll say if spender
does not equal owner. And we'll
revert with a not owner error
that we're going to go ahead and
create up top. So we'll say
error, not owner. And we'll
prepend it with NFT marketplace
with two underscores revert
revert not owner, then will do
underscore for the rest of the
code, and boom, now underneath
are not listed will do is owner
NFT address, token ID message
dot center. So now our list item
checks to see if it's already
listed, make sure that only the
owner of the NFT of that token,
Id can list it. And then it goes
ahead and lists it looking
nicely. Okay, cool. So that is
our list item method here. Now
let's go ahead and do a little
bit of natspec on
this. And now we have a little
natspec here, which looks really
professional. Alright, great. So
we have a list item function.
All right, what's next? Well,
maybe let's make a buy item
function for people to buy their
NF T's after they've been
listed. So let's create them do
function by item. So we'll take
an address, and if the address
un 256 token ID, and this will
be an external function. And
that will also make this payable
an external function because we
know only people or contracts
outside of this contract are
going to call by item and
payable so that people can spend
eath to spend eath, or whatever
layer one currency to actually
buy these prices, we could want
100 percent at channeling prices in now
for listing, we could of course,
add price and then do like, you
know address token price. And do
what we did before with chain
link price feeds to convert the
price of these tokens into how
much they actually cost. And we
could 100 percent do that with chaining
price feeds. But for simplicity,
we're gonna leave that off. But
I will put that as a challenge
to you through challenge is
going to be have this contract
accept payment in a subset of
tokens as well, of course, we
would need to give a little hint
here is channeling price feeds
to convert the price of the
tokens between each other, we're
gonna choose which NFT in which
token ID we want to buy. So
what's the first thing that we
probably want to do? Well, we
probably want to check that this
by item is actually listed. So
we're actually going to make a
new modifier instead of not
listed we'll make it is listed
up and modifiers modifier is
listed. And this is going to
take an address and up the
address un 256 token ID. And to
check to see if this is listed,
we'll say listing memory listing
equals s underscore listings of
the NFT address of the token, Id
sort of go into the mapping
here. And then we're just gonna
check the price. So we'll say if
the listing that price is less
than or equal to zero, so
basically, if there's no price,
if it's defaulted to zero, if
the price is zero, then we're
gonna say revert, not listed.
And after the address, token ID,
and of course, we're going to
prepend. And if the marketplace
and the marketplace underscore
underscore, not listed, and then
we're gonna copy this up here,
we're gonna say air listed, and
this is going to take address,
NFT address, and au int 256
token Id like so, the down in
our modifier, then we're going
to add the underscore and to add
the rest of our code here. So
now we have an is listed
modifier, we're going to check
to make sure that that NFT is
actually listed down here now
we're gonna say is listed
address and ft address or excuse
me, and if the address and token
ID. Now once again, we're gonna
say listing memory listed item
equals s underscore listings.
And if T address token ID, or
say if message dot value is less
than listed item dot price, then
we're going to revert with price
not met. Then we'll do NFT
address, Open ID listed item dot
price Excel so we're going to
create a new air price not met
error. Price not met of course
we're going to prepend this with
NFT marketplace to take an
address. And if the address you
went to 56 token ID and then a
UNT 256 price. So we can see exe
exactly how the price wasn't
met, and then back down here,
we'll get the full error. So we
want to make sure they're
sending us enough money. First
of all, when they send this
money, it needs to belong to
whomever listed the item. So we
actually need to keep track of
how much money these people
have. So let's create another
data structure called proceeds
where we keep track of how much
money people have earned selling
their NF T's. So we'll create a
mapping of address to you and
256. And this is going to be a
mapping of seller address to
amount earned. And we'll make
this private called S underscore
proceeds. And what we'll do is
when somebody buys an item, is
will update their proceeds.
So we'll say as proceeds of
listed item, that seller equals
s proceeds of illicit IO dot
seller plus MSG dot value. Now,
once we buy this item, we're
going to want to delete the
listing. So to delete a mapping
from a wreck, so to delete an
entry and a mapping, we just use
delete s underscore listings and
ft address of the token ID. So
we remove that mapping. And then
finally, we're going to go ahead
and transfer it. So we'll say I
ERC 721 and ft address, we're
going to call dot transfer from
the listed item dot seller to
the message dot sender with the
token ID. Now you'll notice
something here, we don't just
send the seller the money. Now
why is that? Well, solidity has
this concept called pull over
push. And it's considered a best
practice when working with
solidity, you want to shift the
risk associated with
transferring ether to the user.
So instead of sending the money
to the user, this is what we
don't want to do want to have
them withdraw the money, we
always want to shift the risk of
working with money and working
with eath or whatever layer one
you're working with, to the
actual user. So we don't want to
send them the money directly, we
want to create this s proceeds
data structure and we can have
them withdraw from it later on.
Now, we could probably do some
checking here. Or we could say
okay, check to make sure the NFT
was transferred. And if we look
at I ERC 721 though, and we're
looking at the transfer from
function, we don't see it
actually has a return. And if we
go to the IP 721 We can see that
none of these have a return type
though, transfer from doesn't
have a return type here.
However, we do see this safe
transfer from bit safe transfer
from it's going to be a little
bit better, right because if we
look at transfer from transfers
ownership of an entity, the
caller is responsible to confirm
that underscore two is capable
of receiving entities or else
they may be permanently lost. So
maybe instead we want to use
safe transfer from which throws
an error unless message sender
is the current owner and
authorize operator, or blah,
blah, blah. So instead of
transfer from we're going to
actually use safe transfer from
just to be a little bit safer.
So we'll do safe transfer from
instead of transfer from. And
then since we're updating a
mapping, we're going to do what,
you guessed it, let's omit an
event, we'll call item bot. Lab
will be a message that sender,
an empty address, token ID and
for listed item that price. So
off the top, let's create a new
event. To event item bought. And
this will be a an address
indexed fire an address indexed
NFT address an address indexed
token ID and then a un 236
price. Just kidding, that
doesn't look fantastic. This
should be intuitive six. Now it
looks fantastic. Now in this buy
item, we've set this up in a way
that is safe from something
called a reentrancy attack. And
we've been coding these
contracts in a way where we kind
of do all this state change
first. And then we transfer the
NFT that token or etc. But why
are we doing that? Cognitively
we think it might make sense.
Okay, first, maybe we should
actually send the NFT right,
we'd want to send the entity
first.
This is actually a huge security
vulnerability. And to understand
why let's learn about one The
most common hacks in blockchain,
the reentrant. See attack. Now
in this sub lesson, we're going
to talk about reentrant. C, and
in the GitHub repo associated
with this lesson, we're going to
have the code for everything
that we're going to go through
here. And the code that we're
looking at is based off of this
solidity by example. reentrant.
See example. And I have a link
to it in the GitHub repo
associated with this course.
Now, I have a sample contract
here, it's a place where you can
deposit and withdraw your eath.
So what it does is it has a
mapping called balances, where
you can call deposit, and it'll
update how much you've deposited
into the protocol. And then it
has a withdrawal function as
well. So what it does is it
first grabs your balance from
this balances mapping, make sure
that you have more than zero.
And then the way that we've been
sending eath, this whole time,
we do message that sender dot
call, we send the balance, and
then we update bounces of
message sender equals zero. Now
this is the line that actually
makes this contract incredibly
vulnerable. And if we run this
right now, though, we'll say
hey, no, it looks like it's
working as expected, we can go
to deploy a copy the accounts
that I'm working with, like that
in a bounce zero, we can
deposit, you know, it's going
away, let's go to ether, will
deposit to ether, come down,
what deposit now had to balance
bounces up, we'll hit withdraw,
now have bounces goes back to
zero. And it seems like it's
working as intended. Now,
there's actually a way we can
attack this function to drain
all the money in this contract.
And this is what's known as a
reentrancy attack. The two most
common kinds of attacks in this
space are going to be reentrancy
attacks, which is what we're
talking about here. And Oracle
attacks, which usually only
happen when a protocol doesn't
use the decentralized Oracle,
lucky for you, we're teaching
you right from the get go how to
use chain link so that you can
be protected. And it's these two
types of attacks that often
result in the most amount of
money last, there's a
leaderboard called rec dot news,
which keeps track of many of the
top attacks that have ever
happened in the defi space. With
many of them if you go into the
retrospectives are either an
Oracle attack or a reentrancy
attack. And you might be saying,
Hey, where are we just talking
about NF T's this, this doesn't
have anything to do with NF T's
we'll get there, don't worry. In
a new contract below, we're
going to create a new contract
called attack down here. And
what we'll do with this attack
contract is we'll grab this
reentrant vulnerable contract,
we'll say reentrant, vulnerable,
public reentrant vulnerable,
like so. And we'll save that
reentrant vulnerable contract as
a global variable. And we'll say
construct door address,
underscore ranch and vulnerable
address. And then we'll say
reentrant vulnerable equals
rancher and vulnerable at
reentrant vulnerable address.
Now what we're going to do is
we're going to create a function
called attack. And it's this
function that's going to call
withdraw in a malicious way. So
we're going to say attack, this
is going to be an external
payable contract. And we're
going to call the posit on this.
So we'll deposit some money
first. So we'll do reentrant
vulnerable dot the posit
will send a value of one ether.
And then immediately we will
call re N Trent vulnerable dot
withdraw. Now at first glance,
this seems pretty harmless.
But remember, when we call
message dot call like this to
send we're calling back to this
this attack contract. Now when
we call this attack contract, is
there a way to execute any other
code? Well, there is remember
how we learned about fallback
functions. If we put a fallback
function in here or a receive
function. When this code runs
call and seconds our contract
ether we can have it trigger our
fallback function to call
withdraw again. So that will
send our contract more ether
than it's do before we update
the balance. So let's see what
this looks like. So in our
fallback here, we'll say if the
address of reentrant vulnerable
balance is greater than or equal
to one ether aka we're saying if
there's money left in the
contract, then rancher
invulnerable dot withdraw. And
then we'll put to get balanced
function in our attacking
contract. We're going to attack
reentrant vulnerable by calling
withdraw. When we get to this
send section, what are we going
to do, we're going to have our
fallback function trigger
calling withdraw again. Now when
we call withdraw again, bounces
a message that sender hasn't
been zeroed out yet. So the
contract code will go, oh, you
still have some money here.
Let's go ahead and let's send
you that, which will then again,
trigger us to call withdraw. And
so we'll just keep calling
withdraw until we're done. So
let's see what this looks like.
So we compile this, and then
let's go to deploy, first, let's
deploy the reentrant vulnerable
contract. Alright, and we can
have any contract address, you
know, like the one that deployed
it, we can have a deposit, let's
do, we have a deposit one ether
deposit. Now we can check the
balances of it. Copy. Paste
great, is one. So now let's have
a do 10. Deposit, it took the
balance. And now we have this
much in here. So we have this
much in here. And if we
withdrew, we withdraw all of it.
And if we switched accounts, to
somebody else, we hit withdrew.
Nothing would happen because
that other account doesn't have
anything, which makes sense. So
there's a lot of money in here,
right. And if we do get balanced
with the contract, we can see
how much money it has, right? It
has this much money total. Now
what we can do on a different
account, let's choose this, this
brand new account, let's go
ahead and deploy the attack
contract. And we'll pass it the
reentrant value address as an
input parameter. So we'll deploy
that. And now what we'll do is
we'll call attack. And you'll
see even though this contract
doesn't have anything deposited
in the reentrant vulnerable
contract, we will still steal
all the funds in here or just
about all the funds. So right
now hit get balance, and a
reentrant vulnerable, here's
what it is, get balance a here
zero, you know, there's the
address, we had attack now, now
that get bounce, oh, excuse me
in public, and withdrawal should
be payable as well. Now we'll
pass one ether as an input
parameter to our attack
function, and we're going to
deposit just one ether. And then
we're going to withdraw. And
we're going to keep withdrawing,
because our fallback function is
going to keep calling withdraw.
And all we had to do was deposit
one ether, and we're gonna be
able to pull out all 11 that are
in here.
So we'll hit attack now.
Transaction went through, the
new balance of our contract is
12, because the one that we
deposited and then the 11 that
we stole, and the new balance of
our old contract is now zero. So
this is known as a reentrant.
See attack. Basically, since we
call a function in another
contract in the middle of our
withdraw, we allow code to run
on a different contract. And the
code that ran runs on this
contract, recalls withdraw
before balances is set to zero,
we get to here we call the
fallback function of our other
code, and it calls withdraw, and
we need to reread withdraw
before we get to setting
balances a message that sender
equals zero. So this is an
issue, obviously. And there are
two ways we can prevent it.
There's the easy way. And then
the mutex way, I don't wanna say
the hard way, it's just a
different way. So one of the
things you'll always see in
security tools is you always
want to call any external
contract as the last step in
your function, or the last step
in transaction. And we want to
update bounces to zero before we
call that external contract,
because of balances of message
sender is reset to zero before
we call external code, then if
it were to try to re enter this,
it would hit this require step
and just cancel out right here
and wouldn't be able to send any
ether again. So that's the first
step that we can do. The next
step that we can do is using
something called a mutex lock.
And this is what open Zeppelin
does with one of the modifiers
that they have, we can have some
type of a Boolean called locked
or something and just right at
the top, we can just say require
not locked. Otherwise, revert.
And then the first thing we do
in this contract is we can say
locked equals true. And then the
last thing we do in here is we
say locked equals false. And
using this lock in here, we only
allow one piece of code to ever
execute in here at a time and we
only unlock it once the code
finishes. Now open Zeplin comes
with a reentrancy guard which we
can use on our code. And it has
a modifier non reentrant which
does essentially what we were
talking about with our locks it
creates a variable called status
and changes it to enter whenever
a function has been entered. It
runs out code, and then changes
it back to not entered when it's
finishes. And whenever any code
runs, it just requires that it
is not entered. So if we wanted
to use this on our code, we can
import at open Zeppelin, slash,
contracts, slash security, slash
reentrancy. Guard about so we
can inherit the functions by
saying NFT marketplace is
reentrancy guard. And then any
function that we're nervous is
going to have this reentrant see
issue, like maybe by item, for
example, we would just add the
modifier non reentrant. Just
like that. And that'll add that
mutex, that locking mechanism
that we talked about. Now, the
mutex way is a little bit more
explicit with our security,
right? Because we're saying,
Hey, this is locked. This is a
non reentrant function. Still a
best practice, whenever you call
external code, like what we see
here is you do all of your state
changes before you call an
external contract. Now, you
might be saying, Oh, that's cool
at all. But what about how does
this relate to our NF Ts? Well,
imagine for a second, instead of
message that sender dot call,
this is, you know, all success
equals, you know, some NF T dot
transfer from, and then we do
some transfers from stuff in
here. And instead of doing some
fallback stuff, our NF T has our
NF T's function transfer from
the similis code to re enter
into our withdraw. If we have
our withdrawal set up like this,
since we're still calling an
external contract with NFT. To
transfer from that transfer from
in that external contract could
be malicious and try to re enter
our contract. As a best
practice, you always want to
change your state, before you
call any external contracts that
you might not have control of, I
highly recommend playing around
with this a little bit just
because seeing is believing. And
with that being said, again, all
the code for this is going to be
available in the GitHub sociated
with this lesson for this
reentrant vulnerable code. And
with that, let's go back to our
NFT project.
Okay, so now we know why we're
doing this safe transfer from at
the bottom of our function here
at the bottom of our bio,
because if our safe transfer
function from was a little bit
higher, maybe what ends up
happening is we send multiple NF
T's to the wrong address before
we update them. So that's why we
do that. And we favor push over
Paul. As we said, Here, there's
a whole lot of these security
tips that you'll learn going on
through this course and in
solidity. But this is still
fantastic, right, we have our by
item. And we have our list item
functions. Let's do a cancel
item now, or cancelled listing.
So we'll do a function.
Cancel listing we'll do the NFT
address. And the UN 256 token
ID. This will be an external
function. One will want to make
sure only the owner of this
entity can cancel it. So we'll
say is owner.
And if T address, token ID
message dot Sen. Want to make
sure that the NFT is actually
listed. So we'll do is listed
and ft address, token ID. And
great. Now to cancel this, all
we're going to do is we're going
to delete s listings NFT address
token ID, we're just going to
delete that mapping. And then
we'll emit an event item
cancelled message dot sender and
if T address and token ID. And
of course, we're going to create
a new event here. We'll say
event item canceled. And it will
be an address indexed seller
address. Index NFT address. You
want to 56 indexed token ID. All
right. Great. That was pretty
quick. Cancel listening. Boom.
Jack. Done. What's next? Okay,
let's update our listings. So
we'll do function update listing
address and if the address you
went to for the sixth token ID
you went to the six new price
will update the price of this of
this external we'll make sure
it's listed with is listed
say is owner do a token ID and
then we'll do message dot
sender. Now to update our
listing We'll just say s
underscore listings of NF T
address. At token ID dot price
equals the new price that we're
giving it. And then we'll admit,
we can omit like item updated.
But we can also just omit an
item listed with MSG dot sender
NFT address, token ID, new
price. Because essentially, by
updating it, we're essentially
just relisting it with a new
price. So we're just going to do
an item listed event, we only
have one more function to do, we
need to do a withdraw proceeds.
So we'll say function, withdraw
proceeds to get all the payments
for all of our entities. So
we'll get the the proceeds by
doing new activity six proceeds
equals s underscore proceeds of
MSG dot sender, right, we're
getting all the payments that
were collected in by item, and
we're saying if proceeds is less
than or equal to zero, then
we're going to revert with no
proceeds. And we're going to
make this a NFT. Marketplace
underscore underscore no
proceeds. Excel create at the
top error empty marketplace no
proceeds being otherwise, we'll
say s underscore proceeds of MSG
dot sender equals zero. So we're
going to reset the proceeds to
zero, right, we're going to do
this before we send any
proceeds. And then we're going
to do our traditional way we
send payments, so bool success
equals payable, message dot
sender call value is going to be
proceeds all blank here. And
then we could do require, you
know, we could do require
success, or we could say
if not success, reverts revert
with Aleksey marketplace,
transfer failed. And then we'll
make this a new air, air NFT
marketplace transfer failed. Put
a semicolon here. And we're
looking pretty good. Now we even
have a way to withdraw. So we
have our five functions here.
Awesome. Let's just create a
couple of getters. So maybe
we'll do we even copy this.
Paste it here we'll say getter
functions like so. And we'll do
function maybe we'll do get
listing. Take an address, NF T
address, the utilities X token
ID, external view, which returns
a listing in memory. And we'll
say return s underscore listings
of NF T address token Id like
so. And also function, get
proceeds of address seller,
external view returns, you went
to the desex return s underscore
proceeds of the seller. So we'll
get how much money somebody is
owed. And then any listings and
let's run a little compile here,
yarn, or hit Compile or hh
compile just to see where we
messed up. Oh, we did a mess up.
Wow, that's great. And now,
guess what? You have
successfully created a
minimalistic NFT marketplace
that's completely decentralized.
That is pretty wild. And that is
incredibly powerful. And you
should feel really excited for
yourself. Very cool, very good
job. But you know, we're not
done, we got to write some
deploys and some tests. So let's
jump into that. Now since we've
done this a couple of times, I
actually encourage you to pause
the video here and try writing
your own deploy scripts and your
own tests. And then go ahead and
come back and follow along with
us and see if you did it
correctly, we're going to create
a new folder called deploy. Of
course, we already have the hard
hat deploy in our hard hat
config. So we know we're good to
go here. So let's go ahead and
create a one. Deploy NFT
marketplace.js. Now once again,
you've seen a lot of this
before, so we're going to spare
the details do const network
equals require hard hat to
constant development chains,
equal equals require dot dot
slash help our hard hats config,
which we should have let's see.
Do we copy paste it over? No.
Okay, so we didn't copy paste
over Are helper Hardhead config
from the last project, let's go
ahead and grab it. Or we can
grab it from the smart contract
lottery and paste that in here.
And we really only need this
file for the development chains
here. Right for hard hat and
localhost, we're going to grab
the development chains from
that. And then we'll also grab
const. Verify, equals require,
get this from utils. Verify,
right? Do we have utils, we have
verify. Fantastic. Now we'll do
module that exports equals
async. an async function where
it's gonna take get named
accounts and deployments. From
the hard hat input parameter,
and then we're gonna do const.
Deploy comma log equals
deployments. And then const,
Deployer equals await, get named
accounts. Which, of course,
we're getting from our heart
head dot config. We have named
accounts, we have a Deployer.
And we have a player or whatever
you have in here from our last
project. And now does our entity
marketplace have a constructor?
Construct? Nope, no constructor.
So we know args is going to be
blank. And then we can say const
NFT. Marketplace equals await,
deploy. And if T marketplace,
say from Deployer, args is going
to be args. Log will be true.
And then wait confirmations will
be network dot config dot wait
confirmations or one, two, this
is going to be block on for
patients, we'll go to the
config, just make sure that
those are in here. I'm sorry, I
didn't add them in here. So
we'll do block confirmations is
going to be six
for all of our networks. So I
actually grabbed this not from
the last project, it looks like
I grabbed this from the hard hat
starter kit. So I'm just going
to add those block confirmations
in there. And now we're good to
go. Now we're gonna say if we're
not on a development chain, not
development chains that includes
network dot name, and process
study and be done ether scan API
key, then we're gonna go ahead,
we'll do log verifying. And then
we'll do a weight verify. And if
the markets place dot address
with arcs, and then we'll do
like log a whole bunch of
hyphens here. And then finally,
module that exports dot tags
equals all and then NFT Mar good
place. And we can test this
deploy function with yarn
Hardhead deploy. Tada, we did
it. Great. So now we have the
deploy function, we can verify
we have our contract, what else
are we probably gonna need to
do. Since this is an NFT
marketplace, we're probably
going to need some NF Ts. So
what we can do is in our
contracts, and we'll create a
new folder for tests got a new
file in here called Basic NF T
dot soul. And in here, we can
add that basic NF T from our
last project. Or you can just go
to my or you can just go to the
GitHub repo associated with this
course, go to contracts, test,
basic NF t, and then just copy
paste. That works too. So this
basic NF t that we're using is
just pointing to the pug as the
basic NF T for us to use just to
test this out. So now that we
have a basic NFT we're gonna
need to create new file, oh to
deploy basic NF T dot j s, and
we'll borrow a lot of the
boilerplate from over here. So
we'll copy all of this actually
paste it in. We'll say const
args equals blank, and we'll say
const basic NF t equals await
deploy basic NF T. From
Deployer. args is going to be
args. Log is going to be true
weight con confirmations is
going to be network dot config
dot block confirmations or one
and then we'll verify this with
if not develop meant chains dot
includes network dot name and
process dot EMV that ether scan
API key that will say log or To
find dot A dot await there if I
basic NFT dot address, and arcs,
module dot exports dot tags
equals all, and basic NFT. And
we can test both of these with
yarn, art had deploy. And
fantastic. Both of these have
been deployed. Again, you don't
have to pause. But it is a good
way to really hone in to really
sharpen those skills on doing
all this. And repetition is the
mother of all skill. So
repeating this stuff yourself
and thinking through these
problems yourself and trying to
code these things yourself, are
really what's going to make you
successful at this. All right,
awesome. Now that we have our
deploy Betson, it's time to
write some tests. Now, if you go
to the GitHub repo associated
with this course, and you go to
the test folder, the tests and
here are some of the robust,
we've actually written out of
all of our projects, there's a
lot of tests in here. Now,
pretty much everything in here,
we've already learned about and
you already know how to do you
have the ability to do it. So
I'm just going to go ahead and
get you started off, and we're
going to write one test
together. And then I highly
recommend you going back in, you
tried to write some tests
yourself, to get that code
coverage to get that test
coverage to be 100 percent. So let's go
ahead, we'll write one test
together, then you should pause
this video and try to write some
tests yourself. When you're done
writing tests and you think
you've hit 100 percent, feel free to
compare back to the test that we
wrote. So let's create a new
folder called tests. Test. And
in here, we'll do a new one
called unit. And if you want to
write staging tests later on,
you absolutely can we will not.
We'll create a new file in here
called NFT marketplace.test.js.
And we'll start some tests. So
we'll do const.
cert, expect equals require Chai
const. Network deployments,
ethers, equals require hard hat
const development chains equals
require dot dot slash dot dot
slash helper, hothead config.
And we're gonna do the same
setup we've been doing. We'll
say bang development chains dot
includes network dot name,
question mark, describe dot
skip. Else describe. And if NF T
marketplace tests, comma async
function, excuse me, this is
just gonna be a function.
Scrabble oval is just a
function, not an async function,
like so. Great. Now let's get
some variables and do a before
each. So we'll say NF T
marketplace, basic NF T, we'll
create a constant price. So
we're just always set the price
of all of our NF T's to the same
thing. This will be ethers dot
utils dot parse
ether 0.1. We'll say const token
ID for now will always be zero.
And then we'll do before each
will be an async function.
And we'll get out and we'll also
get Deployer. Say deployer
equals await, get named
accounts. We're gonna need to
grab getting into accounts from
hard hat as well wrap this all
up dot deployer Excel and then
we'll also in our heart
hat.config.js. Under get named
accounts, we also have something
called player. Now I didn't talk
about this too much. But we're
going to have a second account
which is defaulted to the first
index, right? So we can do at
the top to come up player. And
we can say player equals await
get named accounts dot player.
Now we have a player and a
deployer account will do await
deployments, that fixture. All
will just deploy all of those
contracts will run through
everything in our deploy folder.
We'll get our NFT marketplace.
We'll say NFT marketplace equals
await ethers dot get contract
and ft. marketplace. And then
we'll do basic NF t equals await
ethers dot get contract. Basic
NF T. The way ethers dot get
contract works is it defaults to
grab thing, whatever account is
that account zero, which right
now is our Deployer. If we want
to call a function on NFT
marketplace, with the player
being the one calling the
function, we would have to say,
entity marketplace equals await
and empty marketplace dot
connect player like this. And
now whenever we call a function,
we would use the player instead
of the Deployer. Sometimes what
I like to do and you'll see this
in my code, is I'll do let NFT
marketplace contract. And then
let NFT marketplace, and then
I'll do NFT marketplace contract
equals await ethers dot
contract. And then I'll connect
and set that to the NF T
marketplace. Yes, we can do, we
can automatically choose who to
connect by placing whoever want
to connect to write and get
contract. But sometimes it's
really nice to be kind of
explicit. So it's really up to
you. I'm going to undo all that,
I just want to re show you that
to make sure that you knew
that's how you kind of switch
around with the different
accounts and the different
users. Now that we have an NF T,
we're probably going to need to
mint the NFT so that we can
actually place it on the market.
So we'll do await basic NF T dot
meant NF t, and then we'll
approve to send it on to the
marketplace. So we'll do a wait.
Basic NF T dot approve and T
market place dot address token
ID, which is going to be zero.
And just like that, the NOC
marketplace remember, it can't
call approve, because it doesn't
own that NF t. So we need to
have the Deployer. Call
approved, right. And remember,
since we're not we need to put
basic NF T in here. Since we
didn't tell ethers who to
connect this to it just
automatically connected it to
our Deployer because that's
what's at account zero. So it's
the deployer calling minting it
and then the deployer approving
to send it to the marketplace.
Only after this approved
function has been called canned
the NFT marketplace called
transfer from all those NF T's.
Now we're just going to do one
test here. We're gonna say it
lists and can be bought. That's
it, and this will be an async
function. And we're just gonna
list the NFT and buy a weight
entity marketplace.if We go to
our energy marketplace, what are
we doing, we're listing it
right, we want to list the item
or with the address token ID and
the price. So we'll do dot list
item. Basic NF T dot address,
token ID is zero, which we've
defined right here. And then
price we've hard coded up here
as well. So we're listing it. So
the deployer owns the NF T, the
player is now listing it, now we
want to buy it, let's have the
player be the one to buy it. So
what we're going to do is we're
going to have to connect the
player to the NFT marketplace.
So we can say const player
connected NF T, marketplace
equals and ft marketplace dot
Connect. Player. And then we can
buy the item by saying a weight
player connected and ft
marketplace.by item. It'll be
the basic and if we look back at
the end of the marketplace, what
does buy item need, needs the
NFT address and the token ID. So
basic NF t that address
and then the token ID and after
this bot, we should check to see
that the player actually does
indeed own that NF team. So we
can say const new owner and we
check to see if that owner is
indeed updated. We can say basic
NFT dot owner of because NF T's
have an owner of function, token
ID and then we also want to see
that the deployer actually is
going to get paid. So we can say
await and if T marketplace dot
get
proceeds of Deployer. So now we
can do assert new owner dot two
string equals player and we can
assert deployer proceeds.to
string equals price.to string
because they should have been
paid that price. And that's
right, it's actually a little
bit easier. instead of grabbing
players from getting named
accounts. It's a little bit
easier just to grab it right
from ethers. So we'll do const
accounts equals await
get signers. And then we'll save
player equals accounts of one
just because when we connect
it's expecting it type of
account and then the the get
named account is a different
type. So Oh, it's just a little
bit easier to actually connect
like this. So now we'll connect
to the player like so just know
that player and deployer are now
different types. So you'll see a
little bit differences there. To
me, this is ethers that gets
signers. And then when we buy
the item, we're of course gonna
have to pass a value, it's gonna
be price, of course, we're going
to need to pay the price of the
NFT. And then of course, this
needs to be player dot address.
And that's the difference right
now we got to do player that
address whenever we want the
address of one of the ethers
accounts. And then this new
owner, of course, should be in a
wait. And now we can run this
all. In Tada, we see things
pass. So our NFT marketplace is
able to facilitate the buying
and selling of an NF T with
arbitrary humans. This is
fantastic. So we just ran the
single test to show a little bit
of the oddities when working
with NF T's and some different
accounts. But 100 percent If you feel
up for the challenge, take this
time, pause this video and try
to write some tests. Remember,
the goal here is for us to do
yarn hardhat coverage, and see
what our coverage is and try to
get it to be 100 percent coverage. If
we run it right now, we'll see
Oh, my goodness, we are missing
a lot of coverage. Here, we have
a ton of uncovered lines, on top
of uncovered functions,
branches, statements, etc. Try
to write some tests to get this
to 100 percent and then come back.
Okay, welcome back. Hopefully
now you've written some tests.
And when you run your tests, you
can get some of them, I look
like this, right. And these are
my tests, these are the tests
that I wrote, you could do more
you could do last. And let's
see, when I run yarn Hardhead
coverage, I even missed some
lines. And I could I could test
a little bit more. So make your
tests even better than the ones
that I made. So these are the
tests from the GitHub repo
associated with this. Now that
we've written some tests here,
let's just write a couple of
scripts. And the reason we're
gonna write a couple of scripts
is we're gonna need these a
little bit later. So we'll write
some scripts to mint, some
amount of teased by some NF T's
etc. And we'll need this to
fiddle around and play on the
front end a little bit later. So
to create a script, again, we've
done this perform, let's do a
script called mint, and list dot
j s. And this will be to mint at
NFT. And then immediately listed
on the marketplace. So let's
create an async function called
mint, and list. And down below,
we're going to call mint and
list I'm going to copy paste
with that same script thing that
we've been doing. Obviously,
instead of Maine, though, we're
calling this mountain list. Now
in this mountain list, where
it's a constant, NFT mark, and
of tea market, place equals
await ethers dot get contract.
And ft marketplace. And right
we're going to import ethers
from hard hat. And then we'll do
we'll grab basic NF t. So we'll
say const. Basic kind of T
equals await ethers dot get
contract. Basic NF t. And then
first we'll mint a basic NF t.
So we'll do console dot log,
maintained at the top. And we'll
do a weight or actual we'll say
const. Mint, TX equals await
basic NF T dot mint NF t. And
then we'll do await min TX dot
Wait, wait one block. And
actually we'll say const. Mint
TX receipt. So that equals that.
And in this receipt, here's
another reason why events are so
good. When we met this NFT.
We're omitting the token ID in
an event in this document ID
event. So we could say const
token ID equals mint TX receipt
dot events of zero. That args
dot token Id like that. And now
we have the token ID. And now
that we have the token ID and
the basic NFT. minted we can now
call on our NFT marketplace list
item. So now we'll say console
dot log. Approving NFT right,
it's gonna be real similar to
our tests here. I'm gonna say
const approval TX equals await
basic NFT data prove
NFT marketplace dot address
token ID and then we'll do a
weight approved TX dot wait one
and we'll do console dot log
listing NF t.at that and then
we'll do const TX equals await
and if T market market place
that list item and we'll do NFT
marketplace that address So can
Id do await TX dot wait one,
console dot log listed and cool.
And we can try this out by
running yarn hardhat node, which
is going to run through our
deploy scripts, right, it's
going to run to these deployed
scripts here. And then in a new
terminal, we'll run our script,
yarn hard hat, run scripts meant
and list dash dash network
localhost. And we missed an
argument, oh, we need a price as
well to list our entity. So
we'll create a constant price
equals and we'll say ethers dot
utils dot parse, ether 0.1. And
we'll pass the price and to the
list item. So oops, and sorry,
it's not the marketplace that
we're listing, the basic NF t
that we're listing, of course,
so run that again. And Bada
bing, bada boom, got some listed
events. And we can see here,
we're doing some listing and
awesome. So now we have a
script. Alright, so now that we
have a script, and we're going
to be writing a couple other
scripts a little bit later, we
essentially have a really solid
repo here are our totally
decentralized, NFT marketplace,
this is absolutely massive, and
you should be incredibly,
incredibly proud of yourself.
Now, of course, this is all
code. And people can interact
with this, if they're software
developers, which is great. But
we're going to want to allow
anybody to be able to interact
and list their own NF t's on our
marketplace. So what are we
going to do? Well, we're going
to want to build a front end for
this. And now we're gonna get
into the second part of this
lesson. So on lesson 15, we just
finished the backend. Now we're
gonna move on to the front end,
we're gonna start with this
morass code. The code for both
of these is pretty much nearly
identical. But we're going to
start with Morales, and we're
going to teach you how to do
both of these. And we're going
to teach you the difference
between the Morales and the
MoGraph. And kind of why we're
even using them in the first
place, we're going to start with
Morales. So if you want to
follow along with this next
section, all the code we're
going to be working with, is
going to be in here. So you
excited, I hope you are because
this is going to be a phenomenal
session, we are about to build
one of the most sophisticated
front ends that we can using the
tools that we have. And like I
said, we showed you a little bit
earlier what this is going to
look like. So let's do a quick
refresher here. So here's what
our front end is going to look
like. But what we can do is we
can connect with our little
connect button, we hit Metamask
Metamask pops up, we'll go ahead
and connect. And now that we're
connected, we can see the
different NF T's in here. And if
we're on an address that's owned
by us, it will say owned by you.
And if we switch addresses, are
you I will go ahead and update,
connect there. And now we're
owned by a different address.
Now if it's owned by us, we get
this little hover that says
Update listing. And right now
it's worth 0.18. That's what
it's listed for on our
marketplace. If it's owned by
us, and we click it, we can
update it to a different price.
Let's update it to 50 eath, or
whatever your layer one currency
is, we'll just save new listing
price. We'll go ahead and
confirm. And I'll say the
listing updated, please refresh,
what we can do them. And we'll
mine some blocks on the back
end, and boom, now we see that
it's worth 50 here. Now if we
switch to a different account,
now we can see owned by Baba
blah, and the hovered now says
by me enough is selected as a
different user, I'm going to get
this transaction to actually buy
it. Now go ahead and confirm
that I'm going to buy it, I get
a little pop up. This is item
bought successfully. Now if I do
a little refresh, we'll now see
that that NFT is gone from the
marketplace since we bought it
right and it's no longer
available to be sold. Now what
we can do then is we can come
over to sell NF tees. And at the
bottom, we'll see a withdraw
proceeds. So whenever somebody
buys an NF T, the NFT
marketplace actually keeps the
proceeds that actually keeps the
result of the sale. So if we
switch back to our address that
had the NFT listed, we can now
see Withdraw 50 proceeds because
we know that we have 50 eath,
because we just bought that for
50. So if we hit withdraw,
Metamask is going to pop up, we
can go ahead and confirm, wait a
little bit as transaction
populates, and boom once it goes
through, and we'll see now we
have zero proceeds. Right? We
withdrew everything from here.
So what we can do now is we can
relist that NFT. So if we come
back, go back to the one who
just bought that at a T if we
know the address and the token
ID of the NF t and we own it, we
can go ahead and relisted you're
gonna place the address in here
with the token Id give it some
sort of price. We'll submit
we'll approve giving the NFT
marketplace access to our or
NFT, to our little doggie. And
then we'll go ahead and actually
send the transaction to actually
list the NFT on a marketplace
that we get NF T listed
successfully. After we move some
blocks in the backend, we can go
back to the front end. And we
now see, it's owned by us,
instead of the original owner,
right and set for 10 ether. And
then we can of course, switch
back to a different user, and we
can have
them actually buy. Alright, so
now that we have the contracts,
we know what this looks like on
the contract side. So now let's
figure out how to do this on the
front end side. So let's jump
into our code editor. And begin
if we're on our hard hat and my
NFT marketplace Free Code Camp
folder. That's great. But we're
going to create another folder,
we're going to CD down and
directory. And we're going to
make a new directory. I'm going
to call it next Jas and if T
marketplace dash FCC. Now you
can do next Jas marketplace dash
mirallas FCC if you want. Again,
we're starting with mirallas CD
next Jas NFT marketplace FCC. So
now that we have this folder,
will do code dot will open up a
new VS code, or you can do File
Open folder and open this new
folder. And we can begin working
in this new folder in here. Now
that we're in our new project,
we're in our new folder, we're
gonna do exactly what we've done
before. Yarn create next app,
period. Okay, we've done our
setup here. Now, I don't like es
lint. So once again, I'm just
going to go ahead and delete
that. And what we're going to
add in instead is our prettier
stuff. So prettier, ignore
prettier RC. Again, some people
may strongly disagree with me on
that, but to each their own
right, this is what I like to
do. So this is what I'm going to
do. Now we have a minimalistic
react project, right? If we run
yarn Dev, we open up our UI on
that site, copy this, or
Command, click it. Tada. Welcome
to next. Jas Yeah, we've got an
x js application. As we know, we
go to pages, we go to index.js.
Let's delete everything in here.
Bom will leave the stuff and
head if it comes with stuff and
head will write Hi, exclamation
mark. We'll save we'll come
back. And now we see Hi. And
I'll zoom in a whole bunch.
Boom. So now we have some
minimalistic reacts minimalistic
next, Jas. Now, I know we
already started the project
here. But let's jump to the
readme that's given to us. And
let's talk about how we want to
do this what we want this to
actually look like. Well, we're
going to want to make a
homepage. And in this homepage,
we'll say we'll have it show
recently listed, NF T's homepage
will show recently listed
entities that will say if you
own the NFT, you can update the
listing. If not, you can buy the
listing. So we'll have that. And
then we'll have a sell page. And
in this page, you can list your
NFT on the marketplace. So these
are going to be our two main
pages, we're gonna have a
homepage and a sell page. Now
we're going to have a ton of
components, but we're really
only going to have two main
pages. So if we go back over to
Pages, right, right now we have
our apps dot j s, which serves
our app, which is cool, which
everything runs through. And
then we have our homepage. Let's
also create right now, our sell
page or selling of T dot j s.
And then in here, we'll just
make this really minimal, that
we can copy most of what's in
here, we can actually just copy
paste this whole thing, paste it
in here. And instead of high,
we'll say sell page. We'll save
that. Now if we go to our
localhost do debt slash sell.
And if T oops, we gotta run. Run
the front end again. With yarn
Dev. Sorry, we'll run yarn dev
again. Now we refresh. And now
we can see sell page. So sell
pages that slash sell page, and
then home is just going to be
high. Okay, cool. So we have our
two pages. Which one should we
work on first? Well, let's work
on our homepage. So we're going
to be in our index.js. I'm going
to keep this front end bit
running, we're going to hide it
oops, that's the opposite of
hiding it, push it down, we're
going to hide it like that. And
let's go ahead and let's start
building this. So we see in our
index js, we have some head
stuff here, I'm going to change
this to NFT. Marketplace.
Description is going to be just
an empty marketplace.
Like so Fabcon looks great. Now
if we do a little refresh, now
it says NFT marketplace up at
the top here, which is good.
That's what we want. Well in our
index page, what's one of the
first things that we're always
going to need to do? You guessed
it, we're going to need a little
connect button right? We're
going to need our users to be
able to connect to to web three
to connect to a blockchain. So
same as we've done before. Let's
go ahead let's create a
components folder. And we'll
create a header component
component Nance folder and we'll
create a new file The header
digests. Now remember, since
we've done this before, with our
front end lottery code, we can
always refer back to the lottery
code as well when we're building
this, okay. And of course, we
have all of the code for this on
the GitHub repo. So you can use
that to what I'm not going to
have you all do is last time, we
did that manual header thing,
right, where we had to do all
the local storage and do all
that crazy stuff, we're not
going to do that. This time,
we're going to just do it the
easy way, we're going to just
use the web three UI kit. So to
use this connect button, we're
going to do yarn, add. And we're
not going to do dash dash Dev,
because this connect button is a
necessary component for the
front end, yarn add web through
UI Kit. This also means we're
going to do Morales and react
mirallas. I said, and this is
where it might be a little
confusing. I know I said in here
that we have both a Morales and
other graph edition. So we're
still going to use the Morales
package in both of them. The
only difference is we're going
to use a Morales server as well
in our Morales edition. And
we're not going to use a morale
server on our the graph edition,
they're both can use the Morales
package because all the open
source hooks and tools are still
incredibly powerful, even if we
don't use the Morales server. So
we're still going to use the
Morales package even when we're
going to be using the graph.
Great. So now that we've added
those all, we're going to do
exactly what we did before on
our last next Jas process. So in
order to use our web through UI
component in our app, dot j, s,
and do import mirallas provider
quotes and without sorry, and
curly brace, it's from react
mirallas like that. And then
we're going to wrap our whole
component thing in a morass
provider. So we're gonna do
return, little open parentheses,
close parentheses here. We're
gonna do rounds provider. And
then we're gonna do in if she
allies on Mount is going to
equal false, because we're not
going to use the server yet, or
else provider. Okay, cool. Now
that we've wrapped our app in a
Morales provider, and go back to
our header, we're gonna say
Export default function header,
we're going to grab our Connect
button from what through your
eye kit. So we'll do import
connect button from web three UI
kits. And then in here, we're
just gonna say return. The next
button. Now what we can do back
in our app, J. S, is we can do
import, import, do header from
dot dot slash components header,
and we have our header, we'll
just put our header right above
the component. And we're going
to add some stuff to the header
in a bit. Let's just make sure
that we're importing the header
correctly. Let's go back to our
UI here. And okay, boom, we have
our connects button. If we click
it, you know, we'll get this
little pop up. And I'm way
zoomed in. So I'm going to anway
zoom in.
Now, what else do we want to put
in our header? Well, we're
probably going to want to like
give this like a name and make
this look a little bit nicer,
probably going to want to a link
as well to our cell NF T page.
So let's create a navbar. So
instead of just returning the
connect button, put this in
parenthesis and we'll have a
return some other stuff too. So
we can use this nav tag, which
usually defines like a nav bar.
So it's really similar to a div,
it's just another tag. Right, so
now we'll put everything into
this nav tag. And in next Jas,
we can actually make links using
the next Jas link tag. So what
we can do in this is link allows
us to basically connect to
different links or URLs in our
application, like so. So we can
do import link from next slash
link. And in here, let's say if
we want it to go to the
homepage, we can make a link.
And we'll say h ref equals slash
equals slash. And inside of
this, we would wrap this in an a
tag to make it clickable. And
then we could just say something
like NFT marketplace. Now if we
save that, we go to our front
end, we now we see have a NFT
marketplace button that we can
click and since we're already at
home, we're not going to go
anywhere. But if we copy this
link section, paste it below,
and we make another one for cell
and f t. And we title this cell
NF t. Now we save we go back to
our front end, we now have NFT
marketplace and sell NFT if I
click sell NF t we now get to
the sell page right we'll go
back to the homepage sell page
flip back and forth. Awesome,
very exciting. So now we have
have an incredibly minimalistic
header obviously looks terrible.
So let's do just a little bit of
formatting. And oftentimes
you'll do the formatting last.
But while we're here, we might
as well do our formatting we're
going to use what if you guessed
tailwind? You guessed correctly.
So remember, tailwind with.
Next. Jas, you can always just
follow along here. And we'll
grab, we'll do the exact same
thing we did before we'll do
yarn, add dash dash Dev, that
stuff right there. And then
we'll run a knit after these
finished
installing. So we'll do yarn,
and then paste that in. And
there we go. So now we've got
our post CSS config, we've got
our tailwind config. We're going
to grab tailwind.config.js.
Paste it in here. And then we're
going to grab Global's dot css
and open up Global's dot css,
paste that in there, and cool.
Now we have tailwind in here.
Now that we have tailwind, we
can do some tailwind stuff to
our header here. Let's let's
create a div for all of these
for everything here, we'll
create a little div for all the
stuff here, we'll make like a
big section for almost like a
big sign saying, Hey, you're at
the NFC marketplace, h1, which
stands for header one, and we'll
give it a class name of padding
y of form. Padding x of four,
we'll do font bold text will be
three XL, and then it'll just
say NFT marketplace. Now we have
this NFT marketplace, which is
nice bolt. Awesome. If you're on
your server you're going to kill
it's going to kill it with Ctrl
C, and then we're going to
restart it. And that's going to
pull in all the tailwind stuff.
And now if we refresh our local
main, we should now see okay,
and if T and F c, r gets place,
right, we now see this and big
and bold, which looks a lot
better. So let's keep going.
Let's give our whole nav a class
name. Equals we'll give it
padding of five, border bottom
to flex flex row justify just if
between n items center. We'll
see how that looks. Haha, looks
a lot better. We're now kind of
like setting this up with a
bottom border kind of stick and
some stuff like this, that looks
much much nicer already. Let's
go down here. Let's make our
buttons have a class name equals
lax lax row items center. And
like I said, this is not a
styling class. So we're not
really going to go over exactly
how we're styling this. And that
is okay. But that's going to
move that over make that look a
little nicer. We'll give our
link here, a class name equals
Mr. For P six. And we'll give
both of these the same class
name both these links, give them
some padding, so they moved away
from each other some margin to
the right, so they're away from
each other. And oh, I forgot to
do this Morales off equals
false. We need Morales auth
equals false so that we don't
automatically connect to a
Morales database or try to
connect to Morales database,
when we connect, we want to just
connect with our Metamask. And
we'll change this to home
instead of the marketplace. But
otherwise, that looks pretty
good home selling of T Connect
button. And we can adjust the
formatting of this to make it
look a little different. But I
think for the most part, this
looks much better,
right? Alright, cool, much, much
better looking header. Here, we
have our app.js setup with the
mouse provider headers
components. Let's now move on to
our index. Let's now move on to
showing these NF T's showing all
the NF T's in our marketplace.
And here's where it's going to
already start to heat up and get
really interesting. And actually
one more thing, we're going to
grab this headpiece in the index
if you haven't. And we're just
going to have it be in the app
JSX. So yeah, and our app.js
we're going to put that header
up at the top, and just put a
little, little div, Div. div,
like so wrapping around this
whole thing. This goes here. And
this way, no matter what page
we're on, we're always going to
have this as our header. And we
don't have to define it each one
of our little our things here.
So we'll do a refresh. And it
says head is not defined. Sorry,
that's because we're going to
need to copy import head from
next slash head. Paste it into
our app that Jas import head
from next head. And now we can
see we're going to empty
marketplace no matter what page
we're on, because we're defining
it at our app level. We have the
header in here, we have this
stuff in here, index almost has
nothing in it now. Let's do
this. So what do we want to do?
We want the homepage aka our
index to show recently listed
NFT. So the question is, how do
we show the recently listed NF
Ts. How do we do that? Well,
let's go back to our contract.
We go back to our hard hat NFT
marketplace So we're looking at
at the marketplace, what do we
have in here? How do we actually
see where NFT is stored? Well,
they're stored in this listings
mapping. However, how do we see
all of the listings that are in
here? Well, this is a mapping,
which means we have every single
address on the planet in here,
we can't loop through the
mapping, we'd have to loop
through every single address on
the planet, which is some
insanely large number that you
and I could never fathom how
many addresses there are. So
what are some solutions that we
can take to this problem, right?
Because we're obviously not
going to loop through
everything. So what do we do?
What's what's kind of the first
approach, one of the first
approaches would be like,
alright, Patrick, well, why
don't we just create an array,
an array of listings instead,
and this might be a good
approach. But what if then later
on, we also want to get some
other weird data, maybe we want
to get all the NF t's a user
owns NF t's a user owns, there's
no array of NF T's that a user
owns. Again, that's just a
mapping. But what if we want to
query some other weird data, or
what if an array will be very
gas expensive, which it is, if
we make this an array to loop
through, it'll be incredibly gas
expensive. So we don't want to
have to go back and change. So
I'm going to I'm going to type
this out. Because this is
important. We don't want to
change our protocol for just the
website, we don't want to change
our protocol for just the
website, or we don't want to
much change our protocol for the
website. Because if we were to
make this an array, it would
become incredibly gas
inefficient. And it would become
much harder to use this NFT
marketplace because it would be
so much more expensive. And as
you build more and more complex
protocols, you're going to
realize that having an array for
every single mapping you have
isn't feasible. This is one of
the reasons where these events
come into play. So every single
time we list an NF t, we call
this list item function. And we
omit item listed, this item
listed event is stored in a data
structure that's still on chain,
but just smart contracts can
access it. However, guess what
can't access it off chain
services can access these
events. So what we do in this
case, is what we're going to do
is we will index the events off
chain and then read from our
database. So what we're
literally going to do is we're
going to set up a server to
listen for those events to be
fired, fired. And we will add
them to a database to query. So
yes, we're literally going to
take every single time an item
is listed, we're going to index
it in a database for ourself.
And then we're going to call our
centralized database to start
and we're going to call that
database to do that. Now the
question then becomes Whoa,
isn't that centralized? Hey,
Patrick, we're talking isn't
that centralized? What the
Hickety heck, and the answer to
that is, it's not necessarily.
So the graph is a protocol that
does exactly this. It's a
protocol that indexes events off
chain, and sticks them into this
the Graph Protocol. And it does
it in a decentralized way,
Morales, the way we're going to
show you first does it in a
centralized way, Morales is
going to do it in a centralized
way, which might be the route
that you want to go for speed
for extra bells and whistles, so
that you can do local
development, which is what we're
going to be focusing on here, or
any of the other functionality
that Morales comes with. Because
Morales does a lot more than
just that. That's something to
keep in mind too, is even though
we are adding a centralized
component, or logic, our smart
contracts, the real bulk of this
application is decentralized.
And you can verify all your
interactions are working with
this decentralized smart
contract, we've actually been
using a lot of protocols that
are centralized, like ether
scan, like open see, and some of
these centralized protocols are
really important to this space.
So we're showing you Morales to
get you familiar with working
with one of these centralized
servers, in case you optionally
want to make an application that
provides a centralized service.
And there's a ton of tools in
the space like opens up and
defender tenderly and more, that
are centralized, but give us
massive, massive benefits. We as
a community are bringing more
and more things to being
decentralized. And sometimes we
need some training wheels to get
there. And then the graph is
going to be the decentralized
way, which is a bit of a longer
process to go main net, but
we'll explain all that when we
get there. Let's learn how we
can list the most recently
listed NF T's and Morales in the
graph. Both have some really
solid videos, I'm going to leave
some links in the GitHub repo
associated with this. So if you
want to learn more, you should
definitely watch both of those
because they are absolutely
fantastic and will help you
understand this event stuff
better. So normally, when we
read from the blockchain, we do
something like contract dot get,
get listing, you know, and then
we put it whatever our input
parameters are. Contract double
blah, so instead, so we're going
to read from a database that
houses All the mappings and an
easier to read data structure.
Both Morales and the graph do
this.
We've been using the morass,
open source packages and tools.
However, Morales also comes
optionally with a server back
end to give your web three
applications more functionality.
However, there's a ton of stuff
that we're not going to cover
that Morales can do to help
build your web three
applications. So instead of me
continuing to talk about
Morales, and what it can do, we
have Ivan here to give a brief
overview of some of the other
things that Morales can do take
it away, and
my name is Ivan, I'm from
rallis. And I'm here to tell you
how you can speed up your
development by 10 times and I'm
not over exaggerating, when
you're building something, you
want to ensure that is scalable,
because your DAP may go global,
it may get viral, it may go
mainstream, it can happen. And
if it happens, you don't want to
start from scratch, you want to
use tools and services that
allow you to go fast, and also
to go big. And that's exactly
what mirallas provides. At
mirallas. We create tools, we
create infrastructure for
developers in a way that you
have a single workflow, and they
will soon explain what it means
because this is what saves you
time. If you have a single
workflow for doing things. And
workflow in web three really
means that you have to have a
smart contract, whether it's a
token, the game, some kind of
staking some kind of
marketplace, some kind of defy,
it will be on chain, but at the
same time, you have to connect
it to your back end. Because
when something happens on chain,
you need to monitor that. So you
can create web hooks, you can
create email, you can create a
push notification, you can run
some custom code, you can run
some calculation, you can save
something to the database,
everything on chain at the end
of the day needs to go into our
back end. And when something is
in your back end, it needs to go
to the front end. So for
example, you change the UI when
something happens on chain or
you change the UI. If your user
receives a transfer there is
above a specific threshold. Or
if your user has this NFC, you
can allow them access into some
kind of chat or some kind of
exclusive piece of content. So
at Morales, we provide you with
a full stack suite of tools that
is used by over 100,000
developers, it's really becoming
one of the most adopted tech
stacks in web three. And it all
starts with Morales identity,
which ensures that you get one
piece of code, you write one
piece of code and you can log in
your users across different
blockchains across different
wallets. And in your morale is
dashboard, you will get the user
profile, and you will get a web
session. So mirallas allows you
to manage identities because a
user profile can have many
different wallets from many
different chains connected to
it. And all of the transactions
will be synced from that user,
all the real time transactions
will be synced about that user.
And also, you have established
web session between your front
end whether it is a game,
whether it is a web website, we
ensure that you have secure
authenticated web sessions, and
we provide you with session
management. So in case you have
your own bike, and then you have
mirallas session identity
management, you can invalidate
sessions, you can log in users
and do all of that great, all of
these great things with one line
of code. That's very important.
Number two is Morales real time
I already mentioned a bit of it.
But basically when you have a
user, you know exactly what's
going on in real time. You can
run custom code, whenever a user
does a transaction, you can run
custom code or do a web hook or
email or push notification
whenever a user interacts with a
smart contracts or when a smart
contract simply emits an event.
This can be an trade in an NFC
marketplace, this can be ERC 20
transfer, you can be very
flexible by setting filters. So
you can say only give me alerts
only give me web hooks when the
user transfers more than 10
NFCs. Or when this token
transfer is above $1,000, and so
on so forth. This is morale is
real time very, very powerful
things. Next are mirallas SDKs.
So whether you're building a
website, whether you're building
a game where full integration
with game engines, whether
you're building for some other
platform, we have extensive SDKs
that are easy to use that allow
you to do all of this that allow
you to connect to Morales and do
this very, very easily. And if
you go to our documentation,
which I highly recommend you to
do, you go to Morales, Doc's dot
morales.io, if you go to Doc's
dot, Marisa Yo, you will first
and foremost understand what
mirallas is in depth. So you can
think of it kind of like
Firebase, but for crypto,
basically, it's a managed
backend, that you can connect
your front end. Also, you can
connect it to your own back end
using no GS SDK, it's very, very
easy. But what I wanted to show
you here is cross platform. So
for each thing we have, let's
say you want to get nfts for
your user, we'll show you how to
do it in simple JavaScript,
vanilla JavaScript, how to do it
and react, how to do it using a
web request. Let's say that you
just want to use a raw web
request. Let's say you're using
some kind of language that we
don't have SDK for you still can
use Morales just that you have
to call the raw HTTP request.
And we'll also show you how to
do it in Unity using C sharp in
Unity game engine. So we're
very, very clear cross platform.
And we are cross chain. So this
means for example, when you log
in the user, you can create the
user profile where you have the
lambda address, let's say your
user uses Solana then they can
easily connect Aetherium, they
can easily connect Binus chain,
the end, we're gonna add more
chain soon, they can easily
connect L Ron, to one user
profile. And then you have all
kinds of different wallets,
different chains, and you have
one single user profile one
single user ID. This is, by the
way, how it will look like in
your database. As you can see,
you're going to have a user user
table right here, you're going
to have all of their accounts.
So in this case, I only have
eath. But if I have Solana, if I
have other types of blockchains,
it will all be right here. And
this is a database that also has
all my transactions. This is a
database where I can set up
different listen events or smart
contracts. So for example, open
see I can watch open see smart
contracts or something else. And
it's very, very variable,
because this is MongoDB. This is
MongoDB, you can run MongoDB
queries, it's very, very
variable. So in that sense,
mirallas gives gives you a nice,
nice dashboard with everything
you need to know about your
users, their sessions, their
permissions, and so on, so
forth. And of course, you can
connect to your own back end
using the Node js SDK. So this
is Morales SDKs. And finally,
when we're speaking about the
workflow, the final thing is the
API's, which I also already
showed you, but the API is that
you can do RAW requests from any
programming language from any
kind of architecture. So using
this workflow, you can easily
achieve anything you want very,
very quickly. You really have to
try Morales it is it will change
your life. I can explain here
all I want, I have limited time.
But as you can already see, by
this presentation, you're very
curious, as you already can see,
by this presentation, you want
to try this as you already feel
by watching me here, you are
very, very excited. We have to
get your hands dirty. So go,
number one, two dogs, authorize
the sale, and go here getting
started connector SDK in vanilla
or react and go through all of
this. See the magic for
yourself. And if you want
practicalities, go to youtube
channel and go to morality Oh,
slash projects, guys, you all in
the community. Using Morales,
you will succeed using rallies,
you will achieve your goal. And
you're going to do sooner than
you expect yourself. You're
gonna surprise yourself. But
don't let yourself down. Go to
morales.io sign up, get started,
you guys. Now that I've
explained all of that, what does
this look like? Well, this is
where we're actually going to
start using mirallas with its
server capabilities. And we're
going to sign up for a server
here. And we're going to use
Morales as our back end for our
application. So to get set up
with Morales, we go to
morales.io. We can go ahead and
sign up for free. We'll put our
email in, we'll create some
password. Why are you here?
Other please specify Patrick's
amazing hardhat video, you don't
have to write that. But if you
want to write that you can. What
did you hear about Morales for
the first time? Well, you all
heard about it on YouTube,
because you heard it from me,
and then pick your roll, I'm
going to be a developer, we'll
hit next, I don't want to
subscribe. But I'm going to not
be a robot and create your
account. And it even gives us a
little property or create your
first server. So our back end is
going to use a server to do any
stuff on the back. So we'll
create a server. And if we were
going to do a main net or a
testament, we choose one of
those. But for now we're going
to do a local dev chain server.
And again, this is one of the
advantages of Morales is it
allows us to work with our local
dev chain. For indexing events,
we can actually index our events
from our local hard hat node,
which is incredibly, incredibly
powerful here, so check your
email, and we'll have an
activate my account thing,
email, we'll hit activate your
account. And it'll bring us back
here and we'll recreate and
we'll do local dev chain.
Alright, so now we're going to
create a new local dev chain
server. So we're going to call
this NFT marketplace, we're
going to select the region,
whatever region you want, I'm in
the eastern United States. So
I'm going to choose New York.
But whatever location works for
you, we're gonna do local dev
chain, and we're going to do
eath, local dev chain. And
again, if you're building for
polygon, if you're building for
avalanche, if you're building
for Phantom, if you're building
for any of these EVM compatible
chains, again, your eath local
dev chain, it's going to work
exactly the same. So we're going
to add instance now. And we're
going to create a new
application here. So we're going
to close now we have the server
here, and it says ganache, but
it's really hard hat. Don't
worry about that. Now that we
have our server up, we can go to
the Morales documentation, what
we're looking for is events,
we're looking to sync with
events. So we can even do a
little search in here for
events. And we see smart
contract events platform
Automatic Sync, and even tells
us a little bit more about why
do we need to sync and watch
smart contract events. So
basically, this server our
database is going to be looking
for these events to be emitted.
But before we can do that, we
need to hook up our application
to our server and if you go to
the React Morales GitHub right
at the top And you'll probably
see saw this before, when you
have this Morales provider in
their docks, they actually pass
an app ID and a server URL. And
this is how we can actually
connect directly to our servers
on mirallas. So what we're gonna
do is right, now we're gonna go
back to our app that Jas and
originally we've been saying
initialize on Mount equals
false. When we say this, we're
saying, Hey, we're not going to
use a morale server, we're just
going to use the open source
morass tools that y'all provide.
Now, we actually do want to use
their server, right, we do want
to use all these bells and
whistles that Morales comes with
out of the box. So we're going
to change that. So instead of
saying initialize on Mount
equals false, we're just getting
ready with the app ID and the
server URL. So we're going to
delete this. And just like it
says, in the documentation,
we're gonna give it an app ID
and a server URL. So we're gonna
say app ID equals, and this is
where as a string, we'll put our
app ID. So if we go back to our
Morales database, we can go to
view details. And we see all
this information in here. And we
can grab our application ID, we
can copy it, paste it in here.
And then we'll want to grab our
server URL, which is at the top.
So this is the URL of our unique
custom morale server. So we'll
say server, URL equals and then
paste that in there like that.
Now, if you've been following
along with these tutorials, you
might be thinking oh, we're
we're kind of just hard coding
that stuff right in there like
that, how that seems kind of
that seems kind of bad. Well, if
that's your intuition, that is
fantastic. So instead, we're
actually going to put these into
environment variables. So we're
going to create a new file, a
dot env file. And this is where
we're going to put all of our
environment variables. Now next,
Jas comes with built in support
for environment variables, which
allow you to do the following
use dot env, dot local to load
environment variables or those
environment variables to the
browser by prefixing. It with
next underscore public. So
there's a couple of different
environment variable paths we
can use. We can do dot env, dot
local, we can do dot env, dot
this dot that that the other
thing, we're just going to do
dot env, to keep it simple here.
But in order for our front ends,
to read environment variables
from our dot env file, we have
to do next underscore public
underscore, and next Jas will
look into our dot env file for
variables that start with this
and only stick these environment
variables into our application.
If we were to just do like
Morales server equals blah,
blah, blah, it has no idea what
this is because we need to do
next underscore public
underscore. And if we do that,
and we'll do a console dot log,
look here, process dot env. Next
public morale server and we
actually need to kill it and
restart it. And then we go back,
we do a little refresh here,
it'll say Look here as a do bla
bla bla, because that's what is
in the dot env file with that
next public. So we'll grab our
app ID, we'll copy it. And then
our dot env will do next public
app ID equals and we'll paste
that in there. We'll grab our
server URL, we'll go back to
here. We'll do next public
server URL equals, we'll paste
that like that. And now at the
top, we'll say const. App ID
equals process dot E and V dot
next, public app ID. And then
we'll say const. Server URL
equals process dot E and V dot
next public server URL. Now that
we've had these variables, we'll
stick them in like this.
So this is how we can connect
our application to our morale
server. Now, of course, we
haven't done anything yet. But
we're getting started, right?
This is how we're going to
connect to it. Now that we've
signed in, well, I told you that
our morale server was going to
be indexing our events. And if
you go to this Dashboard button,
this is our entire database.
Everything in this browser tab
is what's in our database right
now. And as you can see, right
now, there's not a whole lot of
anything, if we had any events
data in here, it would be in
here. So we need to tell our
server, hey, you need to start
listening for events. So we can
show the most recently listed
entities. So morale server, you
need to start listening, you
need to create a database entry
for every single one of these
item listed events. And whenever
somebody buys an item, right,
whenever somebody buys that
item, or cancels an item, you
need to remove that from your
database. How do we start
telling Morales to start
listening to our events? Well,
first off, well, first off,
we're gonna need to connect it
back to to our blockchain. And
then we're going to say, which
contract which events and what
to do when it hears those
events. So we need to connect it
and then we need to tell it what
to do when it hears those
events. So how do we connect our
mirallas server to our hard hat
blockchain? And right now, we're
not running one. But let's go
ahead and we'll start up our
hard hat, our local host
blockchain. So in one terminal,
we're running the front end and
another terminal will see the
download directory. We'll cd
into our hard hat NFT
marketplace dot Free Code Camp
or Free Code Camp, and we'll do
yarn hard hat node. And if we've
done everything correctly, it'll
deploy our NFT marketplace.
It'll deploy our Basic NFT and
then it'll start local HTTP web
socket at blah, blah, blah. So
that's good. So now that we have
that Node running, what we can
do is we can go to view details,
and go to dev chain proxy
server. So this dev chain proxy
server is going to be how we
actually tell Morales to listen
to our locally running hard hat
node. Now, to do this, what
you're going to need to do is
we're going to need to download
this what's called a reverse
proxy. And I have a link to this
in the GitHub as well, depending
on what computer you're running
on will tell you which one of
these we actually need to
download. And then there's some
troubleshooting tips down here
if you ever get lost, and if
you're really, really confused,
what we can do what Morales FRP
to download, do a quick search
on this. We even come right to
the documentation, connecting
ganache to Morales note for Mac
users download FRP dot Darwin
dot bla bla bla for the nosh
proxy server. So I'm on a Mac.
So I'm going to download this
Darwin AMD 64. And for look at
the releases, that's the first
one at the top, Darwin AMD 64.
So this is the one that I'm
going to go ahead and download.
I'm gonna click it, I'm going to
download it. Once I have it
downloaded, we're going to open
it up, and we're gonna get a
folder and we're gonna get a
folder that looks like this. The
main things that we need are
going to be f RP and FRP C dot
ini. F RPC is going to be the
executable it's going to be what
we're going to run to connect
our blockchain node to Morales,
and F RPC dot ini is going to be
basically the config file to do
this. Now, again, this is one of
the sections where downloading
this is going to be one of the
hardest steps here. So if you
get lost, please ask questions
in the GitHub, please ask
questions in the Morales forum,
there is a Morales forum as
well, where you can ask a ton of
different questions. And please
check out the troubleshooting as
well. But what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a new
folder in here new folder called
F R P. And I'm doing it in here
just to make it a little easier.
But you could really put this
wherever you want, and then
always refer back to it. And
what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take I'm going to copy
these two files, and place it
into this FRP folder. So now I
have FRP C, and F RPC that ini
if you click on the F RPC, it's
going to be like, hey, it's
binary, you can't really look at
this, don't click that, it'll
just be a whole bunch of
nonsense, but the F RPC dot ini
looks like a pretty typical
config file. And this is what
we're going to adjust. If we
even go back to our morale
server, it'll give you what you
need down here. And we're using
hard hat. So we're going to copy
everything here. We're gonna go
back to our F RPC dot ini, and
then just paste whatever is in
there in here. And that's how
we're going to tell this F RPC
thing that we need to connect. I
haven't tried this out for users
using WsL. So if you're using
WsL, let us know in the full
blockchain solidity course, Jas,
make a new discussion, if you
haven't seen it already, saying,
Hey, I'm using WsL for the F
RPC. And here's what you need to
use. And then at the bottom, it
says, run and enjoy. I'm running
on a Mac OS, which runs Linux
commands, so I can just copy
this, I'll create a new
terminal. And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to cd into that
FRP folder. And I'm going to
paste that thing that I just
that I just copied from Ross. So
we're running that F RPC
executable dash c, which is dash
config, F RPC dot ini. If I hit
Enter, it's gonna say log into
server success, get run ID,
blah, blah, server, UDP port,
and then a whole bunch of other
stuff. If you're seeing success
stuff here, that means you did
it right. And you can hit CTRL C
to cancel because we're not
going to keep running it. Now,
if you want to just run this,
you absolutely can. But I'm
going to show you another way to
do this. And this is using the
Morales admin CLI. So everything
that we're doing here, all these
buttons that we're pressing,
Morales actually comes with this
thing called the Morales admin
CLI or the command line
interface. So this is a way for
us to connect and run all these
buttons and stuff that we're
pressing right from our terminal
and right from our shell. So I'm
going to show you a couple of
commands on how to work with the
admin CLI. And we're going to be
working with a lot of admin CLI
commands. But all we're going to
do is npm install dash g
Morales, admin CLI or for us
yarn Global Add. So we're going
to grab that will do yarn,
Global Add routes, admin CLI
like that. And now we should be
able to run Morales admin CLI
and see a whole bunch of stuff
like that. And if you ran
routes, admin CLI, we have all
this stuff. And one of the big
ones, one of the important ones
that we're going to be working
with is this connect local dev
chain. So running this F RPC
dash c dash f RPC ini. That's
going to be the same as running
this connect local dev chain.
Now what I like to do is jump
into our package dot JSON. And
we'll create an additional
script in here for us to just
run yarn, whatever the name is
that we want, and just to do
that, and just to make it a lot
easier for us to connect our
local dev chain so underneath
lint, I'm going to do a calm
Ma'am, I'm going to create a new
command. I'm gonna say Morales
sync. And we're going to run the
Morales admin CLI version of
this f RPC dash c thing. So what
we're going to do in here is
we're going to say mirallas
admin CLI, connect local dev
chain, dash dash chain, hard
hat, dash dash mirallas. Capital
sub domain.
This is where we're going to put
the subdomain of a morale
server, which if we go to, we go
back to our routes, admin data
servers, we can go back to
server details. So it's going to
be not the HTTPS, it's just
going to be from here all the
way to the.com. So not even the
port, we're going to grab that
we're going to paste that there.
And then we're going to do space
dash dash f RPC path is going to
be dot slash F RPC, slash FRP
slash F RPC. Now if we save
this, and we run it, it's not
going to work though. So if I
run yarn with our new script,
Morales sync, it's gonna say
specify Morales API key, it's
going to give us this prompt.
And in our dashboard, we have
our API key, which we can copy,
we can paste it, and then API
secret, we can copy and then
paste it. And then we'll say
starting connection to hard hat,
which is great. But that's
really annoying. And I don't
want to have to do that. So
we're going to Ctrl C, we're
going to kill that. And what we
can do is we can go into our dot
env. And we can actually add
those as environment variables
that Morales is expecting. So
when we run this Morales admin
CLI, it'll check our dot env
file for Morales API key, which
we can copy right here. And then
Morales API secret, which we can
copy, and paste right here. Now,
the reason that these aren't
capital and doing next public,
these are not going to be part
of our front end piece. These
are keys that we're using on the
back end to test and for our
local dev chain connection. So
we don't need to do next public,
we're just going to leave it
like this. But now if I hit up
and run yarn Morales sync,
again, it's not going to prompt
me this time, it's just gonna
say starting connection to hard
hat. And if you see this, this
starting connection to hard hat
bit, we can come back to our
servers, we'll go to dev chain
proxy servers, we'll hit this
disconnected button and refresh.
And if you see connected, you've
successfully connected our heart
add node, which is running here
to our Morales server, which is
awesome. And in fact, if you sit
on your heart had no terminal,
you'll see the actual RPC calls
to our blockchain here. And
you'll see Morales is
consistently calling f block
number to make sure it's up to
date with what it has. So how do
we tell a morale server to start
listening for events? Well,
there are two ways we can do
this. The first way is with the
user interface. So we can go to
view details, we'll go to sync.
And right now it says no sync
services installed. So we'll hit
Add a new sync. And we can see
sync and watch address and sync
and watch contract events, we
can watch the address for
transactions or we can watch
some address for any events. And
we can manually add all our
information here, you can select
the chain description, decide if
we want to optionally sync
historical, we could put the
topic of the event, the ABI of
the event, the address of the
event filter, and then a table
name. Or we could do all this
programmatically, which is what
we're going to do, we'll create
a little script that we can run,
tell our morale server to watch
for those scripts. And we'll see
our database get upgraded to
listen for those events. So back
in our code, we're going to
create a new file called add
events that Jas now we have one
terminal that's running our
front end one terminal that's
running our blockchain one
terminal that syncing our
blockchain with morass. And now
we're going to do another
terminal. For anything else we
want to do like run little
scripts become the Morales
docks, and you click connect
with SDK, there's a ton of
different ways we can actually
connect with the SDK, we've
already learned how to connect
with react by using React
Morales. Now we're going to
connect with no JS since we're
going to run a little Morales
script. And here's like a little
example of what it looks like in
the documentation. But I'm gonna
go ahead, so I'm gonna say const
Morales, equals require oralis
slash node. And we're going to
import the node extension of the
Morales package into our script
here, we're going to require dot
env
dot config, which means we're
going to need to install dot env
yarn add dash dash dev dot env.
And now we have to tell our
morale server all the same
information that we would need
to tell it on the user
interface. So one of the first
things that we're going to need
is the address of our contract.
We're gonna need to say const
contract address equals and this
is where we go oh, well, how do
we how do we get that contract
address? The easy way to do this
is we just go back where we're
running the blockchain And we'd
grab where that NFC marketplace
is deployed. And similar to our
smart contract lottery where we
created an update front end
script, we're gonna do the exact
same thing here. So back in our
heart hat, NFT marketplace, and
if T code, we go to our deploy
script or deploy folder, we're
gonna create a new file called
99 Dash update, front end dot j
s, and we're gonna create a
little bit of our deploy process
that will automatically update
our front end. So we can just
grab the network address from a
file that is programmatically
created. So we're gonna do
module dot exports equals async
function. And now we'll say if
process dot EMV that update
front end, then console dot log,
updating front end so that in
our dot EMV, we have update
front end equals true. And that
will be how we decide whether or
not we actually want to update
the front end. And then we'll
create a function called up date
contract addresses, which we
will await. And this will update
the contract addresses of our
front end. So let's make that
function. Do async function
update contract addresses, make
sure those are spelled the same.
So we'll say const NFT, market
place equals await ethers dot
get contract. And then yes, we
need to import const ethers
equals require hardhat, we'll
grab the NFT market place. And
then we're going to want to
write our files in here to
someplace in our front end code
for us, we're going to do in a
new folder constants. And we're
going to create a new file in
here called network mapping dot
JSON. And we'll have this just
be a JSON object which keeps
track of all of our deployments.
So if we deploy something to
rink V chain will keep a list
will keep a list of it will say
NFT marketplace will keep a list
of all the addresses of the IoT
marketplace, comma basic NF T,
right, and then I list of all
those right now we don't have
anything deployed. So we'll just
have it be an empty JSON object.
Now back in our deploy script in
the hard hat NFT marketplace
project, we're going to keep
track of that location. So right
at the top, we're gonna say
const. Front, and contracts file
equals, and we'll place where it
is according to your file setup.
So if I do cd dot dot slash,
next JS NFT, marketplace, free
code, Camp constants, network
mapping dot JSON, this is where
mine is. So you're going to want
to put it wherever your location
is in relation to your heart at
Mt marketplace Free Code Camp,
it's my front end contract file,
it's going to be right here. Now
that we have all that we're
going to get the chain ID. So
we're gonna say const, chain ID
equals network dot config dot
chain, id.to string. And we're
going to need to import network
from hard hat as well. And then
we're going to want to read from
this network mapping file to see
what's currently in there. So
we'll say const. Contract
addresses equals and we're gonna
do a JSON dot parse Fs dot read
file sync, front, and front and
contracts. File comma UTF,
eight. Now here's what we're
gonna say, if chain ID is in
contract. addresses, let's say
if this list of contract
addresses doesn't include the
marketplace, then added on,
we're gonna say if contract
addresses of chain ID of the
NFT. Marketplace will say dot
includes NF T, market, Mar get
place dot address, then so we'll
say contract address says chain
ID NFT marketplace, dot push NFT
marketplace dot address else
we're gonna say contract
address says of chain ID of NFT
marketplace, which is going to
be a new entry now equals NFT.
Market market place dot address.
So now we've updated our
contract addresses object and we
just need to write it back to
the network mapping. So now
we're gonna say Fs dot right
file sync front and contracts
file comma JSON dot string five
contract addresses and then at
the bottom we'll do module dot
exports dot tags equals and
we'll say all or front end. Now
what we can do is we can run
just this update front end
script with yarn hardhat deploy
dashed dash, network localhost.
And we only want to do this
update front end script. So we
say dash dash tags front end,
and we run this, and I ran into
an error FS is not defined, oh,
I forgot to do const Fs equals
require Fs stride again, cannot
set properties of undefined NFT
marketplace. Oops. And that's
because this line is off instead
of this line, sorry. Basically,
right now, what it's saying is,
it's saying, hey, this NFT
marketplace thing doesn't exist.
So we need to make it exists. So
now we'll say contract addresses
of chain ID equals a new entry
of NFT marketplace and adds its
first parameter, it's going to
be NF T, Mark gets placed dot
address, like that. Now we can
run it, and updating front end
looks like it's done. So if we
go back to our front end, we now
see we have an entry for
localhost with NFC marketplace
with the address in our network
mapping dot JSON. So if you did
that correctly, you should get
this. If not, if you're having a
hard time with that you can, of
course, just go ahead and hard
coded in but I do highly
recommend you do it
programmatically, because your
life is going to be a lot
better. So cool. We have this
update front end script that
works now, so we can put this
back off to the side. And let's
keep going. So we now have this
network mapping file with
contract addresses based off of
the chain ID. So what we can do
is we can pull that in as well,
we'll say const contract,
address says equals require dot
slash constants, slash network
mapping dot JSON. And now we can
get the contract address based
off the chain ID. So we'll say
chain ID equals process dot E
and V dot chain ID, or 31337. So
in our data and V, we'll make a
new entry called Chain ID. And
for now, we'll do 31337. And now
we can get the contract address
by saying contract address
equals contract addresses at the
chain ID of n, f t, Mark get
place of zero. So we're going to
go into that network mapping, go
to the chain, Id go to the NFT
marketplace and get the most
recently deployed NFT
marketplace boom. So now we have
the contract address contract
address says Excuse me. Now in
our add events, we'll create a
new function kind of similar to
what we're doing, we'll do async
function main. And this will be
our main function. And then of
course, we're going to copy
paste that main script thing
we've been doing this whole time
domain dot then catch blah,
blah, blah, we go back to the
morass documentation, though, we
can see we're going to need to
grab our server URL, app ID
master key, and then start it
up. So we're gonna do the exact
same thing. So once again,
sorry, before we even get into
our main, you can do it in your
main function, if you want.
We'll say const server URL
equals, and we can just grab
this once again, from our web.
So we'll say process web dot
next public Morales server URL,
we'll get the app ID equals
process Studien v dot next
public Morales app ID, and then
we'll say const, master key
equals process study v dot
master key. So we don't have a
master key in here yet. So we'll
create a new one called master
key. We'll go back to our
Morales front end, we'll close
out of this, we'll hit View
Details. And we'll grab that
master key. So we'll copy that,
go back to our code editor and
paste it in. And now we have a
master key in our web as well.
We don't want our master key on
our front end. So we're not
going to put next public like
that. Now, the first thing we're
going to do in our main function
is we're going to do await
Morales dot start server URL,
app ID and master key as the
input parameters for this will
do a little console dot log,
working with contract address,
contract address. Now we're
gonna go ahead and add all those
same pieces that we see on the
UI. So what are the events we
want to listen for? Well, if we
go back to our code here, so we
have our NFT marketplace, where
just type in event we have item
listed item bought an item
cancelled. So we have three
events we want to listen and a
Morales, they have this add new
events synced from code, which
we're basically going to be
following. To do this, we need
to obviously start and then
create our options for the
event. We have the chain address
topic, abi elimite, table name
and sync historical and then we
just do Morales dot Cloud dot
run, watch cloud event options
use master key. And that's
pretty much it. So we're going
to follow these documents here
to do our code. So let's start
with item listed. Let's create
some options for our IDed listed
event. So we'll say let item
listed options, or we could do
const if we want to, but I'm
just gonna do let item listed
options equals. And first we're
gonna need the chain ID, which
we have, because we're getting
it from Morales. Now the first
thing to point out about chain
ID is that ralis understands a
local chain is 1337. So even if
you're on 31337, if you're doing
a local development, you got to
switch it to 1337. So we're
going to make another variable
called Morales chain ID. And
we're just going to say, let
Morales chain ID equals chain ID
equals 31337. Question mark
311337. Otherwise, chain ID but
we're saying since Morales
understands that any local Dev
is going to be 1337, we're going
to say if chain ID equals 31337.
Then have Morales chain ID equal
1337. Otherwise have an equal
whatever whatever our chain
ideas and in our dot env we can
decide okay, if we want to do
rink B, localhost main net, etc.
We're gonna say Okay, chain ID
morass will do your Morales
chain ID, comma, we'll say what
else do we need? We did the
chain ID, we're gonna skip
description, a sync historical.
So hit sync historical allows
the node to go back throughout
the blockchain, grab all the
events ever emitted by that
contract. Since this is a very
small local blockchain will just
say sync historical is true.
Like that. Okay, what else do we
need? Okay, we need the topic,
the topic is going to be your
event information. So to get the
topic, go back to our event
code, and the topic is just
gonna be the name of the event,
plus the type of the parameters.
So we're gonna go back to our
code, we're gonna go back to
here, we're gonna say, topic is
going to be item listed, and it
takes an address, an address, an
address, you went to 56, and a
UNT 256, address address, you
interviewed six, YouTube and
six. Those problems seem like
that, we also need the API of
just the event, which again, we
can find we go back to our hard
hat project, we go to artifacts,
we go to contracts. And if the
marketplace dot soul NFT
marketplace dot JSON, our ABI
starting from here is going to
be the ABI of the whole
contract. And we just want that
item listed event. So we did
Ctrl F, and we found it here.
And we're going to grab from
right after it says type event,
we're going to copy we're going
to scroll up to write up to
anonymous false, right, so this
bit describes the ABI of the
event. So we have internal type,
address, name, seller type,
address, and if T address token
ID price item listed, right, so
this is going to be the ABI of
our just our item listed event,
we can take that and we just
stick it in here, hit save, and
mine auto format it to get rid
of the parentheses. Okay, what
else do we need, we have the
topic, we have the ABI, we
already have the address, we're
not going to do a filter. And
then we need a table name. So
we're going to do a new line,
we'll say table name, it's going
to be item listed. And this is
going to be the name of the
table that we update in our
database. So we're gonna get a
new table in here called item
listed, and it's just gonna be
filled with information about
the item listed event. And
that's it right and we would hit
confirm if we were doing this on
the UI. And since we're doing
here, we'll just hit save, this
is one of our events, we want to
do this for all of our events.
Let's do it now for item bought.
So we'll say let's, item bought
options, equals and we'll repeat
the process, some of the stuff
at the top is gonna be the same,
the chain it is gonna be the
same sync historical is gonna be
the same. So we can just grab
those two, paste them down here
for item, but the topic is going
to be different. The topic is
going to be item bot is the name
of the event, it's going to take
an address, an address, a un 256
and a un 256. The ABI is going
to be different. Once again,
we're gonna go to our Hardhead
NFT marketplace, we'll look for
a bot, you'd find this event
here. We'll copy this, go back,
we'll paste it in here, we now
have item bot, we'll give it a
table name of item bot. And then
one more then we have let item
cancelled options equals and
we'll do chain ID that's going
to be rouse chain ID gonna be
the same boilerplate from the
top address. Contract address
topic is going to be different.
The topic for this it's called
item cancelled, and it takes an
address, an address and a UNT
256 will say sync. Historical
will be true, historical is
true. And then we need the ABI.
Once again we can go back to our
hard hat, compile information we
can look for item cancelled,
grab that ABI of that event.
Copy that. Come back to our
running code pasted in. Oops and
I didn't give item canceled.
Let's give item canceled the
table name, which will be item
canceled. So now if I zoom out
just a hair, I now have item
cancelled options, item bought
options. And item listed options
are telling Ross Hey, listen for
these events, whenever you hear
an item canceled event, stick
all this stuff into a database.
Whenever you hear an item bought
event, stick all this in a
database, whenever it emits an
item listed, stick all this in
in a database so that we can
read from it. So we're indexing
these events so that we can
query them much easier. Now to
send them up to our our server
will say const listed response
equals await or Alice or Alice
dot Cloud dot run, watch
contract event will pass the
item listed options. And then
one more comma, and then we pass
an object in here where we're
just gonna say use master key is
going to be true. And we'll do
the same thing we'll say const
bot response or passing the bot
item options. So we'll say bot
response equals await or else
dot Cloud dot run, watch
contract, event, comma, item
bought options. Comma, use
master key that's going to be
true. And then finally Kant's
canceled response equals await
oralis dot Cloud dot run, watch
contract event, comma, item
canceled options, comma use
master key is going to be true.
Now this Morales dot Cloud dot
run API call to our server that
we're making is going to return
a response. And let's look at
the docs to actually see what
that response looks like if it
worked out. Well. In the
terminal, you'll see success
true. So this is the return
we're getting from the API. So
just to make sure everything
goes well, I'll do an if listed.
response dot success, we're
getting that success object from
the rails server, we'll just do
a console dot log success
database updated with watching
events. And then else we'll say
console dot log, something went
wrong with a duck. And of
course, we're not just looking
for let's say response dot
success to be true. We also want
canceled response that success
and bots response
is successful. Then say hey, you
did it. Otherwise say hey,
something went wrong. So this is
how we're going to
programmatically tell our server
our database to listen for
events. So we just do await
Murata Clodagh, run, watch
contract events, we pass it this
object with all these parameters
and flags in there. And then
that's it. And then we can send
them is because I put next
public Morales server URL. And
in my DMV, I just have next
public server URL. So let's
change the name here. Looks like
our server URL was wrong. And
our app ID name is also wrong.
So let's fix that next public
app ID master key looks correct.
Okay, cool. So let's know things
right? More Alice, like cada
run, Rasta cloud run, when we
run this in our database, if we
hit refresh, right now, we don't
see those tables in here. But
once we run this, add events.js,
we should call our server and we
should tell it hey, you need to
add these tables. And you need
to start listening for those
events. So in a new terminal,
we're going to run this add
events such as, so I'm going to
make the terminal nice big. And
this is where if something goes
wrong, it can be a little
frustrating to figure it out how
to fix this. So if you run into
an issue here, if something's
not working as expected, please
use the GitHub repo associated
with this course. And also the
Morales forum is here for you,
and Stack Exchange Etherium. So
we're going to run Node, add
events, dot j s, and we'll hit
enter. Okay, boom, now we see
success database updated with
watching events. Now, if you ran
into an issue, and you rerun it,
and it gets something went
wrong, there's a chance that it
could still be correct, right,
because it returns false. It
returns that there's an issue if
any of these already have the
table in there. So if we go back
to our database here, and we hit
refresh, I can now see item
bought, item canceled and item
listed in my database. And
again, you can see them by
hitting the drop down on your
server and hitting dashboard. We
also see event Sync Status. And
this is how our database knows
that it needs to be listening
for some events, and it's got
all the information about how to
listen for our events in here.
So cool. So now we are listening
for events. This is fantastic.
So now what this means is our
database is now listening To our
blockchain node, and it's
listening for events in here
it's listening for these item
listed item bought item,
cancelled events. So let's go
ahead and test this back in our
hardhat NFT marketplace Free
Code Camp window. We have some
scripts in here. One of them is
mint and list. So we went to New
NFT. And we listed on the
marketplace when we list an NF
T, well, our mirallas database
should hear that item listed
event and go ahead and stick it
into this item listed table that
it made. So for us to test this
out, let's open up our terminal
in our Hardhead NFT marketplace
repo. And we'll run Minton list
for our localhost before we
actually run it, just be sure
that our hard hat node is synced
up with our Morales server in
order for your database to
actually grab that event. Your
local hard hat node needs to be
connected. So we'll do yarn,
hard hat run scripts, mint and
list.js dash dash, network
localhost. Let's enter. Okay,
minting, approving listing
listed now if we flip back to
our database, after a quick
refresh, what do you know, we
see that there's an indeed an
item listed events in our
database, we can see information
about a tool we can see there's
a block hash, a timestamp, we
see the token ID that was
listed, we see the price of the
listing the transaction hash, we
see all this information about
our event. And now it's in this
database for us to query. So if
you have reached this point, you
have successfully set up an
indexer with the Morales
database. And you should be
super pumped because this is
really powerful. And now we're
getting advanced, we're starting
to do some advanced stuff. So if
you've made it this far, huge
congrats. This is already really
cool. Now, some other
troubleshooting help here that
I've run into many times myself,
let's say I've left this
project, and I've killed my
heart hit note, I'm going to
kill it right now. If I stopped,
my heart had node and I come
back to my Morales admin, I'm
going to view details dev chain
proxy server, I'm now
disconnected. And if I hit this
little refresh, I'm disconnected
of course, because I'm not
running my heart headnote
anymore. If I restart my node,
my note is now restarted. My
connects local dev chain command
is still running. If I re fresh
it, it'll now say connected,
which is great. However, if I go
back to my blockchain, or if I
go back to my hard hat, NFC
marketplace script, I run yarn,
hard hat script, mint and list
again, network localhost, I go
back to my database now, and I
do a refresh, we don't see that
item listed in here. So our
mirallas server is looking to
make sure that that the
blockchain we're working with is
the same one. So if we reset our
blockchain, like we did, right,
we canceled it and we reset it,
our database is gonna get really
confused. So what we have to do
is we have to hit reset local
chain, reset local chain, we
want to make sure that our new
local chain is running, and that
we're connected here. So we'll
hit reset local chain, and this
will tell them Ross, hey, we
reset the chain, it's okay,
please continue doing so. And
once we hit reset local chain,
we're not going to see that item
listed in here. However, if we
go back, and we rerun mint and
list network, local host with
this reset local chain. Now, if
we go back to our Morales
database, we hit refresh, we now
see that new one has gotten in
anytime you stopped your hard
hat note, anytime you reset your
hard hat node, the takeaway is
you're going to need to go to
View Details dev chain proxy
server and reset local chain.
Now you can do that
programmatically as well, we're
not going to go over how to
programmatically do that. But
that might be something you want
to add to your hard hat deploy.
The other thing to note is that
it didn't clear out our last
event, right, the last event.
And if I go one minute and list
again, after completes, we'll
have another event in here.
Okay, this is great. So all of
this is being said, the reason
we're doing all this in the
first place is so that in our
index.js we can start listening
for events. How do we show the
recent listen entity. So now we
have a database of listed
entities. So what we could do,
we could just query this item
listed table right and grab
everything in here. However, we
have an issue here, what happens
if someone buys an NFT, if
someone buys an NF T, the item
listed event will still be in
our database. But technically it
won't be on the marketplace
anymore. It'll be gone, it won't
be listed. So what can we do,
there's a number of
architectural choices we can
make to get around this problem
to solve this problem. But one
of the things we can do is
actually we can use mirallas
Cloud Functions. So Morales
cloud functions allow us to just
really add anything we want our
front end to do from the morale
server. And these are functions.
These are scripts that are going
to run on a morale server
whenever we want them to. So we
go to our server hit the little
drop down and we hit Cloud
Functions. Now this is where we
can write somewhere else stuff
to run on our server whenever we
want. And we are going to set up
our Cloud Functions in our IDE
by hitting this little drop done
to actually sync up our Visual
Studio code with our Cloud
Functions, we can just run this
command here, and it will add
whatever cloud functions we have
in some cloud folder to here. So
what we can do back in our VS
code, let's make a new folder,
new folder called Cloud
Functions. And in here, we'll
create a new file called Update,
active items.js. So in here, if
we were to write something like
console dot log, hi, we can
actually have this automatically
saved on a morale server. And
the way that we do this is by
running this command. Now, we
want to make it so that it's a
lot easier for us to run this
command than just always having
to run this massive thing. So
what we're going to do is we're
going to open up our package
json, and we're going to make
another Morales script here,
right below here, we're going to
make another Morales script,
we're gonna say Morales Morales
cloud, and we're going to have
it, run this command. So we're
going to copy this command here,
paste it into our package json.
So it's going to be Morales
admin CLI, watch cloud folder,
we don't need the Morales API
key, because it'll grab that
from our environment variables.
We don't need them rouse secret,
because it'll grab that from our
environment variables, we do
need the morale subdomain
autosave one. And then the
Morales cloud folder is going to
be that new Cloud Functions bid
that we made that slash cloud
functions, functions. Now, in a
new terminal, if I run yarn,
more Alice cloud, which is going
to be same as running this huge
function here, I hit enter,
it'll say compile, you know,
version, blah, blah, compiling,
blah, blah, changes uploaded
correctly. And if we go back to
our front end, we can see this
console dot log ky and our front
end being updated. And if we
continue to run this in our
update active items at Jas, we
could also write console dot
log, you'll save it. And if this
is still running, it'll
automatically upload it. And now
we can see if we do a little
refresh on our front end Cloud
Functions, we can see it's been
uploaded here. Now at this
point, if you have a ton of this
stuff running, you might see CPU
100 percent, you might see this little
thing pop up and the server
might start going a little bit
slower, we're starting to use a
lot of network activity here. So
I'm going to close my yarn
Morales cloud for now. And I'm
just going to upload it once
when I need to. Because we're
connected, we have it listening
to events, we're having it doing
more and more stuff here. And it
can start to put a lot of load
onto the server. So we're just
gonna go ahead and we're going
to cancel that out. And now the
CPU is a lot lower. But if we go
back to Cloud Functions, we can
see it's still in here. And
anytime we update our Cloud
Functions, it'll update our
server with those cloud
functions. And we'll just run
that darn morass cloud once
we're all done here. Anyways, so
right now we're trying to figure
out, Okay, we have item listed,
but if someone buys an item,
technically, it won't be listed
anymore. But our item listed
table will still have it listed.
So what we can do is we can
create a Cloud Function that
runs whenever we want. And like
I said, we can have these run
whenever we want. We can call
these whenever we want. But
we're going to create a Cloud
Function that only runs.
Whenever one of these events are
synced item listed item
cancelled or item bought, we're
going to create a new table
called active item, an active
item is going to say, okay,
anytime it's listed, it will be
active, but when it's bought or
cancelled will remove it from
the active item list. So we're
going to create a new table. So
let's go ahead and do that. We
started off with more Alice
thought. And then if you're IT
auditors that you don't need
this, we don't need to import
Morales here, because we're
going to upload it as a Cloud
Function. And our server already
just automatically injects
mirallas into our scripts. So
we're gonna say Morales dot
cloud, that after save, and
there's a whole bunch of stuff
you can do with your Morales
cloud. And again, you can find
these all in the documentation.
The after save keyword means
that anytime something gets
saved on a table that we
specify, we'll do something. And
it takes two parameters. So it
takes what table that we want to
do something after it's saved.
And we're gonna say item listed.
So we're saying anytime
something is saved to the item
listed table, we'll run some
async function.
And we'll put request in here.
Because anytime something gets
saved, it comes with a request.
So anytime an item listed
happens, we want to add it to
our active items list. And our
requests come with this is
flagged called confirmed. So
we'll say const confirmed
because every request, every
event actually gets triggered
twice. So once a transaction
goes through, it triggers a save
and then once again, once that
transaction is actually
confirmed, we actually only want
to update our active item when
the transaction is actually
confirmed. So we'll say const
confirmed equals request dot
object dot get confirmed.
Screening, get the confirmed
attribute from that request. And
then we're also going to make A
logger will say const logger
equals oralis dot Cloud dot get
logger. And you'll see why in a
second, we can actually write
logs to our Morales database
with this logs thing. So any
logs we can add into here, and
I'll show you that in a minute.
So console logger Morales dot
cloud, get logger. And then
we'll just do logger dot info.
Looking for confirmed x, and we
can actually test this right
now. Right, we can actually test
this right now. In our logs. We
should see looking for confirmed
TX Once an item listed and saved
now to test this out just to
test that our logger is actually
working. Let's run yarn, yarn
Ross cloud just update active
items to our to our morale
server changes uploaded
correctly. Okay, we'll kill it
now. And now in our where we
have our Minton, lists script.
Let's run Minton list. And we
should see on our server we
should get those logs. Now if we
go to our server, we do a little
refresh here. And if we look at
our logs now we can now see
looking for confirmed TX in our
server logs. Now in our logs.
Here we see we only see that
looking for confirmed TX once
and I just told you, it actually
triggers twice once when the
transaction is first sent. And
then once when the transaction
is confirmed, aka has block
confirmations. And additionally,
if we look in our database at
the item listed, and we scroll
all the way to the right, we can
see confirmed equals false. So
we only want to count this item
listed event interactive items
when confirmed is true. So what
we want to do actually is we
want to update our scripts to
add one block confirmation on
top of our local Hardhead
blockchain so that these can be
changed to confirmed now to get
around this. What I usually will
do in my mentalist script is
I'll add a new utility. So I'll
go to my utils, I'll do new
file, and I'll create a move
blocks.js. And this will be a
utility that I use to actually
move the blocks. So when we run
our own heart hat node, we
actually have complete control
over what we want our heart hat
node to do. So what we can do is
we can actually manually mine
nodes and actually move blocks
ahead so that Morales knows Oh,
okay, this transaction is
confirmed, right, because we're
mining the block with the
transaction. And that's it, and
Ross is just going to forever be
waiting for the next block. So
we want to add some
functionality to our scripts,
where we just mine a block after
it's done. Now, keep in mind
that if we mined like 1000
blocks or a ton of blocks really
quickly, Moorehouse might have a
hard time indexing that. So we
really want to just mined one at
a time and give me enough time
to index each block that we
mined. So we're actually going
to build a little script, we're
going to manually mine using
this EVM mine RPC method that
comes with our heart hat
blockchain. So we have this new
move blocks script. And let's go
ahead and make this. So instead
of this being our script, we're
going to have like a main
function at the bottom, we're
just gonna have this be a
utility that we're going to
import into other scripts. So
we're not going to need a main
function here, we're just going
to need to make this an async
function. And we'll call it move
blocks. And then we'll say
amount, which is going to be the
number of blocks, we want to
move, we'll also put a sleep
amount and default it to zero,
this sleep amount is going to be
an optional parameter. If we
want to move blocks and sleep
maybe a second between blocks to
resemble a real blockchain, we
can have that in here too. So we
can have it resemble a real
blockchain by sleeping every
time a block is moved or just
kind of waiting every time a
block has moved. So in our move
block scripts, we'll do console
dot log, moving blocks, dot that
dot, and we'll say for let index
equals zero, and we'll do a for
loop around the amount and call
that EVM. Mine in this for loop
index is less than amount index
plus plus a weight network. And
then we got to import network
oops, we got to import network
from hard hat here, await
network dot provider dot
request. And then we're going to
request the method e v, mime,
comma params are going to be
empty. And this is actually the
same way we can make raw calls
to our blockchain nodes. We
don't do a lot of this because
ethers abstract this under the
hood, but we're making a raw
call to EVM mine. Obviously, you
can't call EVM mine on a real
blockchain because you can't
just tell a blockchain node to
mine the next block. Since this
is our local hard hat node, we
can call the VM now we're gonna
say if sleep amount is greater
than zero, or just if sleep
mount, then we're also going to
have this script sleep or wait a
short duration. So up at the
top, we're actually going to
create a new function called
sleep, which is going to input a
time in milliseconds. And this
is going to return a new
promise, right? Because
remember, in order for us to
wait for some time we got to use
promises, which we've learned
before. And this promise is
going to take a function with
resolve as an input parameter.
And we're just going to say, set
timeout is going to be resolve,
comma, time in Ms. So the way we
can sleep in JavaScript is we
return a new promise. And we
just call this set timeout
function, which basically just
weights the time in
milliseconds. Now to actually
sleep. We'll say console dot
log, sleeping for sleep amount.
And then we'll do await, sleep,
sleep amount, and this is going
to be in milliseconds. So since
sleep returns a promise, we can
call it with await to say, okay,
wait for this sleep function to
finish. And the sleep function
is only going to finish when the
time in MS in time in
milliseconds finishes. So now we
have a function called move
blocks, which will actually
mined blocks on our local
blockchain, so that Morales can
get that block confirmation that
it's looking for now at the
bottom, we'll just do module dot
exports, move blocks, move
blocks, and then we'll also
export sleep as well, because
why not? Equals like that. Now,
what we can do back in our
Minton list, up at the top,
we'll say const, move blocks
equals require dot dot slash
utils slash move blocks. And
then we'll also import network
from ethers network. And the
down in our script. Just right
at the bottom, we'll just say if
network dot config, that chain
ID equals equals 31337 await,
move blocks, we'll say we'll
move to blocks and then we'll
also do sleep amount equals
1000. We'll wait one millisecond
between each block that we
mined. So sleep mount equals
1000, which is going to be one
millisecond. Now let's even just
comment all this out for a
second. We'll just run this
script with only this live.
Right we'll pull this up the
yarn hard hat, run scripts,
mentalist dash dash network,
local host, we'll just move the
blocks move back to our front
end, we'll refresh, we'll go
look at item listed. We'll
scroll all the way to the right,
and now we see confirmed is
true. And now if we were to look
in our logs, we would see that
logging item happened twice.
Alright, so Let's uncomment this
and continue. Now that we have
this now that we're learning
about logging, now that we're
doing all this stuff, we can say
If confirmed, we're going to do
some stuff. If confirmed, we're
going to create a table called
active item and add this to the
active item table. So we're
going to do a little logger dot
info bound item. And we'll
create a new table and a new
entry in this table. So we'll
say const active item equals
more Alice dot object dot extend
ACC active item. This we're
saying if active item exists,
great grab it if not create it.
So we're going to create this
active item table if it doesn't
exist, if it does exist, great,
grab it. And we're going to say
const active item equals new,
active item. So we're going to
create a new entry in this
active item table that we're
creating. And we'll say active
item dot set. And we can set any
of the columns we want for this
new table that we're creating.
So let's give it a marketplace
address column. So we'll say
market place address. And this
will come from the request dot
object dot get address all of
these requests from events come
with the address that they're
coming from, which for us is
going to be the marketplace
address, we'll do active item
that set and if T address which
these events saved come with all
the parameters of our event. So
we'll say request that object
dot get NFT address will get the
price will say active item dot
set price is going to be request
dot object dot get price will
get the token IDs will say
active item dot set token ID
request dot object dot get token
ID and then we'll get the seller
will say active item dot set
seller is going to be request
that object dot get seller. So
we're getting all of this
information from our event. And
this event update from Ross
automatically always comes with
the address that the event was
omitted from. So we're gonna
grab all that we're going to
create this active item table.
We're going to add all these
rows. We're going to add this
one row with all these columns
in it. Awesome. Now we'll just
do logger dot info just to do a
little print out. We'll say
adding address. We'll do a
little string interpolation
we'll say request dot object dot
get address period token ID with
request dot object dot get token
ID. And I need to close this off
here, better. And then outside
of the logger dot info, we'll
just say logger dot info,
saving. And then we just run
await active item dot save. And
now we have cloud function
that's going to create a new
entry in a new table called
active item anytime item listed
happens. So after item is called
the trigger for our cloud
function, and there are a whole
bunch of different triggers for
different Ross Cloud Functions.
If you go to the Morales docs,
we look for trigger, we can find
a list of all these different
triggers in here, like after
save for Save. After save,
before delete, after delete,
before save file, there's all
these different triggers to
trigger this cloud code. Now, if
we upload this new script to our
morale server with yarn morass,
cloud changes uploaded
correctly, okay, great, we'll
kill it. Let's go to our cloud
server, do a little refresh just
to make sure that it's not still
processing that update. Okay,
CPUs low enough. Okay, great.
Now in our database, we don't
see an active item table in
here. But if we go back to our
Hardhead script, and we call
mint and list, since now we have
a Cloud Function that says okay,
anytime an item listed event
happens, update that active item
table, we should see active item
update. So let's run this. And
remember for all of this, we
need to have our heart head node
running connected to Hardhat.
And if we reset our local chain,
we need to click that reset
local chain button. So we went
ahead, we ran this. Now if we go
back to our database, we give it
a little refresh. And right now
I actually don't see anything.
So if I go to my logs go to
info, I can see any errors or
issues in here. So it looks like
after save failed for item
listed for user bla bla bla,
looks like there is an issue
cannot read properties of
undefined reading extend. And
that's also in the info, I made
an issue. I didn't quite write
all my code, right. And if we go
back to our update active item,
I can see where I messed up. It
should be Morales dot object
with a capital O dot extent. So
what I'm going to do, then run
yarn morass cloud again, now
that I have this correct, we're
going to cancel that, we're
gonna run our mminton list
again, now that we've fixed our
script. And now that we've fixed
our script, go back to our
database, we'll give it a little
refresh, I can now see we have
an active item entry in
here. Now at this point, there
are going to be times when you
don't want to leave and go get a
coffee, right, or go to the
bathroom or go get some food.
And you're going to want to stop
your terminals from running. So
let's actually practice
restarting everything and re
getting into this local
development environment. Because
it can be a little weird and a
little tricky. So let's practice
this. So once again, let's come
over here. And what do we need
to do? Well, we're going to Ctrl
C, we're going to kill our
blockchain Ctrl C, we're going
to kill our connection to our
Morales server. And if we're
running a front end Ctrl C, that
too, now if we go to our server,
we go to view details. Dev chain
proxy server, if we hit status,
this reset button here will
still we will be disconnected
now. And now everything has been
disconnected. Now if we want to
restart everything, if we're on
our heart hat NFT marketplace
will run yarn Hardhead node, and
that will spin everything up
again, we'll run yarn Morales
sync to sync back with our
routes connection, we can go
back to our server will do view
details and we should be
connected now. Connected. Since
we restarted our local
blockchain, we now need to
remember to do reset local
chain, we'll go ahead and run
that. Great. If we want to
restart our front end, we can
restart our front end like so
now the thing is, our database
will still have even when we
refresh it even though we reset
the local blockchain, it'll
still have all this stuff in it.
Now these entries in here are
entries from a blockchain that
no longer exists. So what I
often will do is I'll click this
button up here, and we'll just
delete all rows in this class.
To confirm we do active item,
read the name of the table. And
let's do it for item listed too.
We'll select that edit, delete
all rows, item listed. Yes,
delete. We'll do a little
refresh. Now everything is
zeroed out here. Now we have an
empty database for these events
in our after save here. And now
that we've added that little
weight in our script, let's go
back to our hard hat NFT
marketplace, we'll run yarn, RT
hat, run scripts, mint and list
dot j s dash dash network, local
host. This will mint it approve
it listed and then we mined two
blocks to give Morales time to
index our event and then on a
morale server. We go ahead and
refresh we now see item listed
as one and active item is One
all at the same time. So that is
how we're going to make sure
that Morales always indexes
whenever we call a function,
we're just going to mind one
additional block to tell Morales
Hey, that transaction has indeed
been confirmed. So really
exciting. And we got to practice
closing and restarting and doing
all that good stuff, too. So now
this is fantastic. Now that we
have this additional
functionality to make it a lot
easier for someone else over
okay, awesome, we can check
active item. Well, we're not
quite done yet, right? Because
what if somebody buys an NFT, or
sells an entity we should have
active item be removed? Right,
right now there's one item
listed in one active item. But
if we buy an item, active item
will still show that that item
is active. So let's go ahead and
let's update our cloud function
to also say, okay, anytime an
item is bought, we remove that
item from being active. So let's
create another after save. Let's
first built this for canceling
the item. And then we'll build
one for buying the item. So to
make another after save to make
another trigger, we'll say
mirallas dot Cloud dot after
save, we'll say item cancelled.
And this will be an async
function that takes the request
as an input parameter again, and
we're going to do the same
thing. We're gonna say const
confirmed equals request that
object dot get confirmed, we'll
say const. Logger equals routes
dot Cloud dot get logger, like
so. And then we'll do logger.
Oops, lowercase L. And then
we'll do logger dot info,
marketplace, the little pipe
object and then just request dot
object. And then we'll do the
same thing. If confirmed. If
this transaction is confirmed
after one block, we're going to
remove it from active item. And
we're going to be using a query
to first find that active item
that's getting cancelled. And
you can learn more about basic
queries in the Morales
documentation here. So we're
going to get that table by
saying const active item equals
more outlets that object for the
capital O object dot extend
active item. And we're going to
create a new query. So we're
going to query our table before
we actually set or save
anything. So we're gonna say
const, query, query equals new
Morales dot query of active
item. So we're going to query
our Morales database to find an
active item that's in there,
that's going to match the
request here, so we can cancel
it. So we'll say query dot equal
to
marketplace address, comma
request that object dot get
address, we're looking for an
active item where the
marketplace address is going to
be the same as the address of
the item cancelled. We'll say
query dot equal to NF T address,
comma request dot object dot get
an F T address will say query
dot equal to token ID, comma
request dot object dot get token
ID. And that should be it right?
So let's look again at our
contract here. And what is the
item canceled give us it gives
us a seller NFC address and a
token ID seller and ft address
and a token ID. And we're
looking for NFT address and the
token ID, we don't need to look
for the seller, we just need to
look for these two. And then of
course, the marketplace address.
So great. So now that we have
those two, we can say logger dot
info, and then we'll just print
out marketplace type query. And
then we'll just print out this
query that we're running. And
then we can say const, cancelled
item equals await query dot
first, we're going to find the
first active item in the
database that has the same
marketplace address and a T
address and token ID that just
got cancelled. So we're going to
find that first cancelled item.
We'll do a little bit more
logger information, we'll say
logger dot info, marketplace,
pipe, cancelled item. And then
we'll just do some string
interpolation. And we'll print
out that canceled item.
Cancelled item and we'll say if
cancelled item. So if the query
doesn't find anything, it'll
return undefined. So we're
saying if cancelled item which
will return true if it found
something. So if cancelled item,
then we're gonna say logger dot
info. Deleting and then we'll do
request dot object dot get token
ID at address, request dot
object dot get address address
space since it was canceled, so
we're going to do a little print
little logging here. Take the
leading that thing since it was
canceled and then we're going to
run a wait canceled item dot
destroy and that's when we
remove it from the active item.
And then we'll just say else.
Logger dot info, no item found
with address, request dot object
dot get address, and token, Id
request dot object, dot get
token ID. So cool. So now we
have this after save here, it
looks like my terminal
automatically added this require
in here, which we don't want. So
I'm just gonna go ahead delete
that. We can upload this to our
Morales server by running yarn,
Morales cloud and great changes
uploaded correctly. And now to
test this test that this is
working, let's create a new
script in our hard hat NFT
marketplace called cancel item.
So we'll go to scripts right now
we have mentioned list, we'll do
new file, we'll call it cancel
dot Jas. We'll do cancel item,
Jas. And this will be a script.
So we're going to use that that
main thing here, but we're going
to call our function cancel. So
we'll do async function cancel,
and then at the top, we'll say
const token ID equals Now let's
go to our active item list. And
let's find a token ID that's in
here. Okay, token ID zero. And
so we'll use this as the token
ID that we want to delete. So
we'll use token ID zero. So in
our cancel item.js script, we'll
say const token ID equals zero
and let's cancel it. So we'll
say const NFT. Marketplace
equals await ethers dot get
contract. And yes, const ethers
equals require hardhat. And ft
marketplace will say const basic
NF t equals await ethers dot get
gets contract. Basic NF team do
const TX equals await NF T
marketplace dot cancel listing
basic NF T dot address token ID.
And we're going to call cancel
item should be cancelled listing
we call the cancel listing. So
cancelled listing Yep, like
that. And it takes the address
of the NFT and the token ID. So
the basic NF T dot address and
the token D Okay, great. And
then we'll do a weight TX dot
weight one. And then we'll do
console dot log NFT cancelled.
And then we'll say if network
dot config dot chain ID equals
equals 31337. We'll go ahead and
we'll do a wait move blocks to
two and then we'll say sleep.
Mount equals 1000. And then
we'll just say const. Move
blocks equals require dot dot
slash utils slash move blocks.
Okay, cool. That looks really
good. So let's go ahead and run
this yarn hardhat run scripts
cancel item.js dash dash
network, local host and ft
cancelled moving blocks
sleeping. Okay, great. Our node
is running. Awesome. We're
connected to our mirallas we've
uploaded our cloud function with
yarn Morales cloud. Now if we go
back to our database, do a
little refresh. Looks like I
have an issue here. I go to my
info it says after save failed
for item Cancel for user blah
blah, blah. Here's the login
information. Morales dot cloud
apt get latar is not a function.
Uh huh. Well, that makes a lot
of sense. Get water. Let's do
let's make this get logger.
Shall we get logger to let's re
upload them. Changes uploaded
correctly. And now I'm going to
have to manually go to active
item I'm gonna have to manually
delete this one will have a
delete this row. Yes, delete, do
a refresh. And the reason I have
to do that is because it's
already been saved. And we're
doing an after save. So because
I messed up. If you spelt that
right, you probably did, right.
But because I messed up, we're
gonna have to rebuild a new one.
And then delete that new one.
I'm going to run yarn, hard hat
run scripts, mint and list
network localhost. And we just
meant to add a new one. Let me
check the Morales database,
we'll do a refresh. I can see it
in here, I can see it an item
listed. It has a token ID of
one. So let's go ahead and
cancel that now. So I'm going to
change my token ID and cancel
item to one. And now we'll run
that script Barnhardt at run
scripts cancel item, network,
local host run this NFT
cancelled moving blocks. Now
we'll go to the front end, we'll
do a refresh. And we can see
it's been removed from active
item programmatically, which is
great. So this is where these
logs can be really helpful. Now
it can be a little scary to do
things wrong on purpose, but
learning how to use information
like the logging and learning
how to debug effectively is
going to make you a lot faster
of a coder because guess what,
you're not going to be perfect.
You're going to run into issues
understanding how to use The Log
Understanding how to read the
errors is going to make you much
faster developer. So now we have
something for cancelled item,
we're also going to need
something for what? Well, you
guessed it for buying the item.
So let's make another one of
these murales to cloud that
after save. And we're going to
be using most of this same exact
code for item bought that we use
for item cancelled, we probably
should turn it all into a
function. But for practice,
we're just going to go ahead and
do it one more time, we'll do
Morales dot cloud. And then my
VS code keeps sticking this in
for some reason. I'm going to
undo that Morales dot Cloud dot
after save. Item bot is the
event. There'll be an async
request little arrow function
here, say const confirmed equals
request that object dot get
confirmed will get whether this
transaction is confirmed. We'll
get the logger I'm just going to
copy paste so I get it right
this time. So I'm going to copy
and paste those two lines const
logger equals Morales dot Cloud
dot get logger logger dot info.
And we'll say If confirmed const
active item equals Morales dot
object dot extend active item
const query and for this query,
I'm actually just going to copy
these lines because this is
going to be exactly the same.
We're going to look for the NFT
address and the token ID and the
marketplace address. And if we
look in our NFT dot soul and up
to marketplace dot som alright
and bot event as the NFT
address. And the token ID which
is what we want to find are
listed and of team. So we'll run
that query. We'll do const bots
item equals await query dot
first, and we'll do exactly what
we did before. If bots item then
logger dot info, deleting
request dot object dot get
object ID await bought item dot
destroy logger dot info deleted
item with Open ID request dot
object dot get open ID at
address request dot object dot
get
address. And then if we don't
find it will say else. Logger
dot info, no item found with
address request that object dot
get address and token, Id
request that object dot get
token ID. Cool. So that looks
good. Let's go ahead and upload
this to the cloud. So do yarn
oralis Cloud changes uploaded
correctly. Let's go make sure it
looks good on our server. So
we'll give a morale server a
little refresh. Go to Cloud
Functions here. I can see the
item cancelled in here still.
And now I can see the item
bought after save perfect. Looks
like I'm at 100 percent capacity. So
we're gonna give it a second
just to cool down thinking give
it a little refresh and looks
like we're back down after our
cloud function has been
uploaded. Okay, cool. To test
out that this part is working.
Let's go ahead we'll write
another script here. Do new file
by item dot j s. And we'll do
the same thing right now. On our
database. We don't have any
active items. So we'll just run
real quick. We're on mint and
list. Mint a new one. We'll go
check our database we'll do a
little refresh. Looks like
active vitamins in here with a
token ID of two now. So we'll do
is we'll buy that token ID so
we'll say const ethers network
equals require arhats const move
blocks equals require dot slash
utils slash move blocks const
token ID equals to async
function by item const NFT
marketplace equals await ethers
dot get contract NF T
marketplace const basic NF t
equals await ethers dot get
contract basic NFT coms listing
equals await and ft market place
dot get listing basic NF T dot
address and the token ID will
say const price equals listing
that price that to string and
we'll say const Tx and this is
us going to actually buy it
equals await and ft marketplace
dot buy item basic n f t dot
address, token ID, comma. And
then the value of course is
going to be the price. Do await
TX dot wait one, console dot log
bots NF t. And then if network
dot config dot chain ID equals
31337, then await move blocks to
comma, sleep amount equals 1000.
And then this is a script of
course, so we're going to use
the same stuff we're using for
cancel. But instead of
cancelled, it's going to be
called by item. So we have the
item inactive item here, we run
yarn, art hat run scripts by
item.js Dash network, localhost.
Now we can test buying this
item. Okay, Bob, the NFT looping
blocks, we'll do a little
refresh on our database, and
boom, we can see the active item
is gone. And we can see, the
item has now been bought.
Awesome. We're almost done
keeping our active item, just a
table of active items. But
there's one more thing we should
do. We're not going to test this
here. But if you want to test
it, we can we actually in our
NFT marketplace, go to
marketplace dot Sol, we actually
have an update listing function
as well, that also admits an
item listed. So we also want to
check to see if item listed is
coming from update listening. So
back in our item listed Cloud
Function, before we actually
start saving stuff, we want to
check to see if it already
exists. So we're gonna say so
we'll say const query equals new
mirallas dot query. And sorry, I
keep sticking the sin of active
item. And we're going to do
exactly what we've been doing.
We're gonna say query dot equal
to NFT. Address, we're gonna
look for the NFT address request
dot object dot get and ft
address, query dot equal to
token ID, request that object
dot get token ID, query dot
equal to marketplace, address,
comma request dot object dot get
address query dot equal to
seller requests dot object dot
get seller will say const
already listed item equals await
query dot first. And then we'll
say if this item has already
been listed. Then we'll go ahead
and say logger dot info.
Deleting already listed request
dot object dot get object ID.
And we'll do a weight already
listed item dot destroy. And
then do logger dot info, deleted
item with token ID request dot
object dot get token ID at
address request dot object dot
get address since it's already
been listed, if the object has
already been listed, we know
that it's coming from this
update listing function. So
we're going to delete it first,
and then we'll resave it with
its new price. So and let's just
go ahead, and let's upload this
to the cloud yarn Morales cloud.
upload this to our server
changes uploaded correctly.
Let's go check our server, give
it a little refresh. We'll go
check Cloud Functions. And it
looks like our item listed query
for deleting is now in here. But
with all that, we now have a way
to constantly have this active
item table only be the items
that are actively on our
marketplace without having to
spend any additional gas in our
application. And this is going
to be way better for user
experience because they're not
going to have to pay extra gas
to keep all these entities and
maybe an array or some more data
structures. If you've made it
this far. This is easily one of
the hardest parts of this
course, because we're working
with a ton of technologies.
We're working with a smart
contract, we're working with
Cloud Functions, we're working
with a back end database. Now if
you've made it this far, you
should be incredibly incredibly
proud. So now let's just go
ahead, let's mint and list one
more NFT. So we'll do we'll run
yarn heart at run scripts, mint
and list network local hosts
will meant it will list it or
sleeping. Let's go check our
database. We'll do a refresh. We
see the active item in here. And
now let's learn how to call all
of the objects in In our active
item database here, let's do it.
And remember, if you ever reset
your local blockchain, you're
gonna have to come in here and
delete all the rows in the
support tables.
With all that being said, it's
time to finally come back to our
front end, and come back to our
index dot J. S and answer this
question. How do we show the
recently listed NF Ts, we only
want to show the active NF t's
on the marketplace. And now we
have a system for getting only
the active ones, only the ones
that are currently on the
market, because we're indexing
these events. Now, I'm going to
delete all these comments here.
And let's do this. So what we're
going to do is we're going to do
this thing called use Morales
query. So if we go to the React
Morales docks, there is a hook
called use Morales query. And
this allows us to fetch and make
queries to our database in a
React context. Back in here,
we're going to say, import, use
Morales query from react
mirallas. Now, if you look in
the docs here, use mouse query
returns data error is loading.
And this will automatically run
this query the instant our index
pops up. So to get the data from
the query to get all of our
active items from our database,
we'll say const data, and we'll
rename data to listed and fts.
And then we'll also check to see
if this query is still fetching.
So we'll say is fetching and
then we'll rename that to
fetching listed NF t is equals
use Morales query. And inside
here, this takes two input
parameters, it takes the table
name to do the search on and
then it also takes a function or
the query. So the table name
that we're going to be looking
for is going to be active item.
And then the function for the
query is going to be we're going
to say query dot, we'll limit it
just to 10. So we'll say only
the first 10, we'll do it in dot
descending order, based off the
token ID. And then if we wanted
to do different pages, we could
do this thing called dot skip
with page numbers, we're not
going to do page numbers here.
So we're just going to leave it
like this for now. And that's
it. So we're saying, okay,
great, grab from our database on
the active item table, grab just
the first 10 in descending order
of the token ID. Now it's going
to save the result of this to
this listed NF TS section. Now
to see if this is working. Let's
just do a little console dot log
listed NF t's just to see what
this using Ross query actually
returns for us. And now we have
our local blockchain Node
running, we have our connection
to our Morales server, and we
have our front end running. So
let's go to our front end, we'll
do a little refresh here, we'll
right click and hit Inspect,
we'll go to the console. And we
see we have this array being
spit out here. Now the first
time it console dot logs, it's
empty. This is because when it
initially loads listed out of
T's hasn't returned yet. And
it's so it's actually just going
to be an empty array. But when
it finishes loading, we're going
to get an array of size one, we
get an array of size one,
because active item only has one
enter right now. So we get this
array of size one, and we can
see it index zero, we have class
name active item, we have the
item ID, we have all these
attributes, which are going to
be created at the marketplace
address. And if the address the
price, the seller and the token
ID this is exactly what we see
in our database here. So
Perfect. That's exactly what we
want to be able to show these NF
t's on the front end. So how do
we actually show this NFT and
list this NF T. For people who
aren't developers and aren't
going to go into the console dot
log? Well, what we're going to
be doing is in this return here,
we'll put some parentheses
around this. First, we should
check to see if we are fetching
those listed NF T's. So we'll do
some JavaScript stuff. And we'll
say fetching listed NF T's and
we'll do a ternary operator. So
we're gonna say if we are
fetching those NF T's, let's add
like a little div div that just
says loading that that done,
we'll put a little colon here.
And if we're not fetching, we'll
do we'll say listed NF TS dot
map. So dot map basically loops
through and does some function
on all of the listed entities in
the function we're going to want
ours to do. And it's going to
take each NF t as input
parameters. So we say we're
going to basically loop through
each NF T. And we're going to
say, console dot log and F T dot
attribute attributes with an S.
And then inside of these inside
of this attributes are the
different pieces that we want.
So we're going to get those
pieces we'll say const we want
to show the price. The NFT
address, the token ID in the
marketplace address, which of
course is just gonna be this
one, and then the seller, that's
all this information that we're
going to want to show on the
front end will say that equals
NF T dot attributes. So we're
going to pull these out, and we
can see price seller token ID,
etc. We're going to pull those
out of NF T dot attributes. And
we can show those by in this
function here, we'll say return.
And then we'll return some HTML,
we'll do like div div. And then
we can say like price, price,
price,
period, and f t address and ft
address, token ID, token ID
seller, then added this for some
reason. So I'm going to delete
that add $1 signs before all
these for some reason, delete
those, save. Now if I go to the
front end, I can now see
information about our NFT from
our database is listed here.
That's fantastic. We see the
price we see the address, we see
the token ID we see the seller.
Now if we go back to our NFT
marketplace, our little our
little hard hat MC marketplace,
let's mint another one. Yarn
hard hat run scripts mentalist
Dash network localhost, we're
going to run that it's going to
mint one more. If we go back to
our Morales database, we do a
little refresh on that active
item table, we now have a new
item in here. So if we go back
to our front end, we give this a
little refresh. And boom, now we
have two items in here. So this
is awesome, we now have a way to
actually show the most recently
listed NF t's on our
marketplace, plus ah.
Now, of course, you might be
saying to yourself, hey,
Patrick, that's cool and all.
But that looks really ugly. And
I would agree with you. But 100 percent
agree with you. So we should
come up with a component to show
our listed entities that looks a
lot nicer. So when instead of
returning and just printing out
the raw information, we probably
want to show the image, right,
we want to show the image, we
want to make everything look a
lot nicer. So we're going to
create a new component that
we're going to return in here to
format all of our NF T's
appropriately. So we're gonna go
to components, we'll do new
file, and we're going to call NF
T box dot j s. And this is where
we're going to grab all the
information on how to show what
our NFT actually looks like. So
let's get started working on our
entity box, we're gonna set this
up, the way we've been setting
all these up would do export
default function, and ft box.
Now something that's a little
bit different for this one,
though, is that in our index, we
have all this information. So
we're gonna need to pass all
these variables to our NFT Box
component. So to do that, we'll
add them as input parameters for
our component here. So we'll say
price, and if the address, token
ID, marketplace, address, and
seller. So right now on our
front end, we just have a whole
bunch of text, and we even have
this gross warning, we're gonna
get rid of that tip. And as we
know, tokens have their token
URI, which points to an image
URI or an image URL of what the
actual token looks like. So what
we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to call that
token URI, and then call the
image URI to show the image. So
we're going to actually have to
wait those two API requests to
get the actual image. And we're
going to save that image as a
state variable on this component
here. So as you already know,
we're going to work with use
state to keep track of that
image URI. So we'll do import,
use state from react like this.
And in here, we'll say const,
image, Uri, comma set image, URI
equals use state. And we'll
start it off as a blank string.
Now let's create a function,
we're going to call it update UI
to update our UI and grab this
token URI and the image URI. So
we'll create an async function
called Update UI. And in order
to get the image first, we're
gonna need to get the token URI,
and then using the image ag from
the token URI gets the image. So
first thing we're gonna have to
do is get the token URI. So we
know how to do this with use web
three contract. So we'll do
import, use web three contract
from react Morales. And as we
know, use web through contracts
is going to need some
parameters. So we'll say const
run contract function, get token
URI, equals, use web through
contract. First, we need the ABI
of the NFT because we're gonna
need to call token URI. So to
get the ABI we're gonna need to
once again update our front end.
So let's comment this part out.
We'll go back to our hard hat
piece. And let's look in our
deploy scripts. We have this
update front end right now. All
this is doing is updating calm
object addresses. Well, that's
good. We're also going to want
to add API's to our front end as
well. So let's create another
function in here called Update
API. And we'll pass the API's as
well. So we'll do async function
update API. And we'll give it
both the basic NFT API and the
NFT marketplace API, because
we're going to need both of
them. So we'll say const NF T,
marketplace equals await ethers
dot get contract. And f t
marketplace, we're going to
write the ABI to the front end
API location, we have the front
end contracts file. So let's
also do a const. Front and ABI
location equals, and we'll do
dot dot slash next, Jas, and if
T marketplace dash FCC slash
constants, and instead of
actually just giving the file
name, we can just give it the
front end API location. And then
we'll actually have it generate
that file for us because we're
just going to overwrite the ABI
file anytime we work with it. So
now that we have the
marketplace, we'll just do Fs
dot right file sync, and we'll
do front and ABI location, and
ft marketplace, dot JSON. And ft
marketplace, dot interface that
format ethers dot utils dot
format types dot JSON. So we're
also going to want to do that
for the basic NF t. So we'll say
const basic NF t equals await
ethers dot get contract basic NF
T Fs dot right? file sync, it's
going to be that exact same
place right here. Except for
it's going to be a different
location, it's going to be basic
NFT dot JSON. And of course,
we're gonna do a comma basic NF
T, that interface dot format
ethers dot utils, dot format,
types dot JSON, you can find
this NFT marketplace that
interface in the Hardhead
documentation. And you can find
this in the ethers
documentation. So now we have
this update ABI function. Let's
also add this to our module that
exports so we'll do a weight up
the ABI like that.
There's a hyphen here that
shouldn't be here. And we'll run
just this part of our hardhat
front end, run yarn, hard hat,
deploy dash, dash dash tags, the
tag here is front end, front
end. And now it's had nothing to
compile updating front end, it's
done. So if we go back to our
front end, now, we go to our
constants, we now see two
objects in here, which are going
to be API's, the basic NFT, and
the NFT. Marketplace. Awesome.
So now that we have that, we can
import those into our front end.
So we can say import, and if T
marketplace, abi from dot dot
slash constants slash NF T,
marketplace dot JSON. And we can
also get the NF T API. So we'll
do import NF T, abi from that
the slash constants slash basic
NF T dot JSON. Now in our run
contract function, our token URI
function is part of the NFT API.
So the API will be the NFT, abi,
the contract address
is going to be the address of
the NFT, which we're passing in
as a parameter. So we'll pass an
NF T address, the function name
is going to be token URI, and
the params are going to be the
token ID, which is getting
passed as an input parameter to
this function to this component.
Right. And we can double check.
We're good to our basic NF T dot
soul, right? We scroll down, we
have this token URI that we're
overriding. And this is the
function we want to call takes
the token ID. So this the
the token ID. Okay, great. So in
our update UI, first, we'll say
const, token URI equals await
token URI. Now let's do a little
console dot log token your eye,
just to see what this returns to
make sure that update UI is
called, we'll add it to a use
effect, we'll say use effect.
And this takes an input
parameter of a function to do,
we'll just say Update UI. And
then we'll only have this run
anytime is web three enabled
changes. So we want to run
update UI, but we want it to be
dependent on is web three
enabled. And then we'll say if
it's web three enabled, then
update UI. So we need to add use
effect as well. So we're using
use state, we'll do comma, use
effect. And now we should at
least be reading our token URI
off the blockchain. We're not
going to set the image yet,
right, because we're going to
get the image URI from the token
neuron. Let's add this NFT box
to our index to see if it's
working well so far back in our
index Next, up at the top, we
will import NF T box from dot
dot slash components slash NF T
box. And down here, while we're
returning this will add our NF T
box component will make sure to
pass in all the parameters it
takes. So the price is going to
equal that JavaScript price. And
ft address is going to equal the
JavaScript entity address. The
token ID is going to equal the
token ID, marketplace address is
going to be marketplace address
seller is going to be the
seller. And you saw that warning
where it's saying, hey, all the
components need to all the
things in the mapping need to
have their unique key. So we'll
say key, we'll give these all a
key as well. We'll say key
equals this, we'll do some
string interpolation, we'll just
say the NFT address, combined
with the token ID can be the
key. So if we save that, go back
to our front end here, do a
little refresh marketplace
address is not defined market
place address. So let's make
sure we spell things right,
let's go back to the front end,
we'll give it a refresh is what
three enabled is not defined.
Oops, excuse me in the NFT box,
we need to grab that from us
Morales, so we'll import use
Morales. And in our ponents here
we'll say const is web three
enabled equals use Morales.
We'll save that. And one thing I
noticed actually is this needs
to be wrapped in squigglies.
Sorry, I forgot to do that. Our
component actually just takes a
props, props input parameter.
And we would need to do like
props that token ID to get token
ID. But instead, we just extract
it out by doing putting the
little squiggly brackets here.
So put the squiggly brackets
there. Great, we'll do a little
console dot log token, your eye,
or index.js has everything
updated. Here. Let's do a little
save. And we can even say if is
web three enabled up the UI.
Like that we'll save we'll go to
the front end, we'll do a little
refresh. We'll see if
everything's working as
expected. And as long as we're
on that hard had localhost and
our meta mask. And again, you
can ignore this error, this
warning that's up here for now.
And if you click this, and you
have your IPFS and brave or your
IPFS companion, we can now see
we're getting our token URI,
which is perfect. The piece that
we want now is this image bid.
And for this one that I'm using
it is an HTTPS, which
technically isn't decentralized,
right, we would need it to come
from instead of HTTPS, we would
need to come from IPFS colon
slash slash but but actually
having it as HTTPS ipfs.io. For
now was good, we'll explain why
in just a second. Now that we
are getting the token URI, we
can call this URL, and we can
get back the image that we want
to actually show on the front
end. So in here, we'll do a
little console dot log, the
token, URI is string
interpolation, like this, and
then we'll say if token URI,
we're going to need to now grab
this token URI, and get the
image from it. And this is where
we're going to get a little bit
funky. And we're going to cheat
a little bit. Now for our
application, not everybody is
going to have IPFS companion,
not every browser is IPFS
compatible. So we're gonna have
to actually cheat a little bit
here, we're actually going to
change the token Uriah from its
IPFS edition to an H HTTPS
edition. And this is known as
using an IPFS gateway, which is
a server that will return IPFS
files from a normal URL. So
we're going to use an IPFS
gateway, which we can just make
regular HTTPS calls to, and it
will return those IPFS files. So
technically, are we making the
centralized doing this? Yes. And
is that ideal? No. However,
until the world adopt IPFS, and
until the world adopts the
standards, it's kind of what we
have to do right now. Because
otherwise, the front end will
just show up as blank to them.
And we can't have that we don't
want that. So we're gonna say
const request URL equals token
URI dot replace IPFS, slash
slash with HTTP s, HTTPS.
slash slash ipfs.io/ipfs/so.
We're saying, if you have a
token URI that starts with IPFS,
that's great. But we're going to
switch it to using an IPFS
gateway. It's really use the
IPFS gateway provided by the
team that builds IPFS. So pretty
reliable gateway is is kind of a
cop out. Yes. Are our files
still on? IPFS? Yes. So it's not
the end of the world. But this
is just going to make calling
these API's a lot easier for us.
And we're going to say const
token URI. Response equals
await. And this is going to be a
little weird. We're going to do
two awaits. await a weight fetch
request, URL dot JSON. So fetch
is a keyword you can use in
JavaScript to fetch or get a URL
fetch keyword is essentially
doing the same thing as pasting
this into the browser, like so.
And getting this JSON response.
So we await to get the response.
And then we await to convert the
response to JSON. And that's how
we get the toggle response. So
we now have this object in our
JavaScript, which is perfect
because this object has this
image attribute that we want. So
we're gonna do the same thing we
did here, we're gonna use the
IPFS gateway, this one's already
using HTTPS that ipfs.io. But if
it wasn't, we would still want
to convert it. So now we're
gonna say const. Image URI
equals token you are i response
dot image. So we're gonna get
the image tag of this response
here. And then we're going to
say const. Image URI URL, is
going to equal to, and we're
gonna do the exact same thing
that we did up here, we're going
to use the gateway image URI dot
replace IPFS, colon slash slash
with HTTPS ipfs.io/ipfs. And
now, and that's how we get this
URL right here. And so we can
finally do set image URI, to
that image URL. And now we have
our image URI is going to be
that image right here. Now, is
this a little bit wonky? Yes.
Are there better ways that we
can do this? Yes, there's
actually a number of better ways
that we could do some of this,
we could actually, since we're
using Morales, we could render
image on our server and just
call our server, what else could
we do well, or test nets and
maintenance routes actually
comes with a bunch of hooks like
us NFT balance that will show us
an F TS show us how many NF T's
shows all this information about
NF T's but it only works on test
nets and main net, we'd have the
world adopt IPFS. So we don't
have to do this wrapping.
Unfortunately, it doesn't yet so
such as life. But now that we're
setting the image, alright, we
have this image URI, we have
what this actually looks like,
we're going to have this and if
we click on this, we use this in
our browser, it returns this
dog. So now we have the image
URI in our website, we can
finally use it to show what this
is going to look like. So
finally, we can create a return
in here. So down below, we'll do
return to a little div. And then
we'll do another div just
because I want to. And we can do
some JavaScript, we can say if
if that image array exists,
we'll do some stuff. Otherwise,
we'll do some other stuff. So if
it doesn't exist, maybe we'll do
a div for now. div that just
says loading dot the dot. And if
it does exist, for now, we'll
just say, just do a little div,
close the div. And we'll just
say found it. Now if we go back
to our front end, let's see if
we're good here.
Uh huh. If I do a refresh, we
see found it for both of these
NF T's. Okay, cool. So how do we
actually show these NF T's, we
finally have the URL that we can
use to show the NF T's. But we
want to actually use them next.
Jas actually comes with a
component called the image
component that we can use to
render images really easily just
by using a URI. Now, because
we're going to use this image
tag, and because it does some
optimizations on the back end,
that means that this website
won't be able to be deployed to
a static to a static site, like
IPFS. Because now our website
requires a server technically,
requires a server just because
we have Morales. So that might
be another reason, we might not
want to, since we're using this
image tag, we can't deploy this
statically to something like
IPFS is we're going to up at the
top, we're going to import image
from next slash image. And we're
gonna down here we're going to
say, instead of founded, we're
gonna go Image, we're gonna
close it off here, too, we're
gonna give a loader of just a
blank function that just gives
us the image URI. Don't worry
too much about loader. For now,
we're gonna say the source of
the image is going to be the
image URI. And then we'll give
it a height of maybe 200. And
then we'll give it a width of
also maybe 200. And if we did
this right, after we save, we
should see the image on our UI.
So we'll go back to our website,
and oh, my goodness, we can see
the dogs holy cow. This is
getting really exciting. We can
see the puppies, we can see the
images, we're definitely doing
something right here, which is
really exciting. Now I know I
said this before that this isn't
a CSS. This isn't a formatting
tutorial, because that's
definitely not my expertise.
However, let's make this look a
little bit nicer. And we're
going to use once again, the web
three UI kit, because the web
three UI kit has a whole bunch
of tools that are really, really
helpful for us to use. So if we
go to the web three UI kit, we
can go to that live storybook
Another interactive bit, and we
can scroll down to the section
that has called card. Or we can
make these little clickable
cards and we can display some
information about our nfts. So
let's go ahead and at the top,
we'll do import import card from
web three UI kit. And now
instead of just showing the
image, we'll wrap the image in a
card like this. We'll save that.
Now back on our front end, give
it a little refresh. Now we've
got this kind of clickable
section that looks a little bit
nicer. We'll even label it. And
we can even label it with a
title and description. Now we
can grab the title and the
description from the token URI
response. So up at the top,
let's go ahead, let's grab the
title and the description of the
token UI as a state variable. So
we'll say const, token name, set
token name, equals use state,
start off as blank, the const
token description, that token
description, equals use state.
Start off as blank to download,
we do this update UI bit, we'll
call set token name. So we'll
say name is token, your response
dot name, we'll say set token
description, which will be
token, your response dot
description. And then we'll use
those descriptions and title in
the cart. So we'll say title
equals token name, description
equals token description. Save
that. We'll look at our front
end here. Give it a little
refresh. Oh, and now we have the
name of the NFT. And its
description on our front end.
Okay, cool. Let's keep going.
What else do we want on this?
Well, we probably want who it's
owned by. So we'll put a little
div inside the card, say div,
maybe we'll even put the token
ID we'll do a little number.
With the token ID.
We'll do another little div, and
then we'll make this italic.
We'll say class name equals
italic. And then text is going
to be small. And we'll say owned
by, and this is where we can get
the seller that we're passing in
as an input parameter. And then
maybe underneath the image, we
want to put the price. We'll do
a little div here. And then
we'll say price like this.
However, we're probably don't
want it in way we want it in
human readable units. So we'll
import ethers, we'll say import
ethers from ethers. And then
instead of just showing the
price, we'll do a little, little
JavaScript and here we'll do
ethers dot utils dot format,
units, price, price and ether.
And then we'll do space eath.
And then we'll make this be
class name equals font bold, so
we can read how much it's listed
for on our marketplace. Let's go
back a high we can now see, this
is token ID number four. We can
see who it's owned by we'd see
the price of it and then more
information about the dog. Yay.
Now let's format all this stuff
in here a little bit nicer. So
let's wrap everything in a div
in one more div. And that will
say class name is going to be
flex. And this is going to help
format everything, we'll put
everything in a column items and
get to. And now if we look back
there, kind of like in a column
now, wrapping one more div, give
them some padding, last name
equals P to say a little bit
padding has been added. Okay,
nice. And then we'll go back to
our index, and we'll add some
formatting to our index here. So
our main one, we're going to
remove styles dot container,
we're just gonna say container.
MX auto, we're going to make an
h1 in here, class name, equals,
I form E X for font bold text to
XML. This is we're just gonna
say recently listed, then we're
going to do another div. Class,
name equals flex, flex wrap.
We're going to end this div
around our JavaScript here. And
let's look at our UI. And let's
see what that does. Okay, cool.
Let's go back to our index.
Let's remove all this stuff.
Since now we're adding that to
the card. Let's save. Now it's
looking a lot better, we finally
able to start listening our NF
Ts and then have them show up on
our marketplace like we see
here. Fantastic. Okay, if we go
to the readme homepage show
recently listen to empties. Oh,
my goodness, this is a check
we're done here. Now, and I know
what seemed like a lot of work,
but a lot of it was setting up
that morale server correctly.
And because we have our own back
end, now, we have some back end
services that we needed to
configure. But now that
everything's set up, the rest of
this is going to be easy St. Now
we are only going to want this
to show if we're connected to
web three. Right? Now, if we
click this, this still shows up.
So we're going to have to update
this a little bit. And in our
index.js, we're now we're
checking to see fetching.
Listen, NF T's right before
that, right? Before we do that
we actually want to see is web
three enabled. And this is going
to be a little bit of nested
tertiary operations. If web
three is enabled, then we're
going to do all this fetching,
listed NF T's stuff here. We're
gonna do everything in here. So
if it's not enabled, let's do
like a little div that says web
three, currently not enabled.
And of course, we're going to
need to grab is web three
enabled. So we're going to say,
for the top we'll do const is
what three enabled equals use
oralis as we've been doing, and
we're going to grab use Morales
from react Morales, we'll save
that go back to our front end,
give it a little refresh. If
we're connected, we'll see the
marketplace. If we disconnect,
we see web three currently not
enabled, which is what we want.
Perfect. So what is next in our
readme. If you only NFT, you can
update the listing. Let's first
let's figure out if somebody
actually is the owner of these
entities. Let's make it really
easy for the people on this
website. Well, first we can get
the person's Metamask by
grabbing the account from us
mouse, so we'll do a comma
account. So then we can easily
just do const is owned by user
equals seller equals equals
equals account. So the seller
we're getting from the contract,
the account we're getting from
whoever's connected here, if the
seller equals the account, there
is no seller equals equals
equals undefined. We'll just say
they're owned by you. And now
instead of saying owned by
seller, we can say const,
formatted seller address equals,
and we'll do the ternary
operator will say if it's on by
you, then we'll just say you
instead of seller. Otherwise,
we'll say seller. Now we'll say
owned by formatted seller
address like this. So if we go
back to our front end, we do a
little refresh. depending on
who's connected, you might see
owned by blah, blah, blah. Now
if I go to my Metamask, let me
go ahead and switch account to
account three, let's go ahead
and connect our account three,
we now see owned by you instead.
Right, and we can even switch
again, we'll switch accounts
again, we'll switch to account
one, we now see owned by blah,
blah, blah, like so since when
we switch back and forth, the
diameters of this actually
change which is really annoying.
So maybe we want to go one step
further. And we want to truncate
this seller address make it a
little bit smaller. So we want
to make a seller a little bit
smaller. So let's create a new
function. And we can create this
outside of the export default
function because this is going
to be a function that doesn't
depend on anything inside our
app. It's just going to be kind
of a raw function. So we're
going to create we'll call it
const truncate string, and this
is going to be a function that
takes a full string, and a
string length as parameters. And
we're just going to pass the
seller address and how long we
want to make this string. So
this is going to be an arrow
function we're going to do here,
and we're gonna say, if all
string dot length is less than
or equal to str Lang, return
full str. Otherwise, we'll say
concept ra torx equals three
little dots. And we'll say,
Let's separate Tor length equals
Sep. Ra Tor dot length. To make
con separator length, we'll say
const chars to show is going to
be the the string length minus
the separator length, we'll say
const. Front chars or front
characters is going to equal
math dot ceiling chars to show
divided by two const back chars
is going to equal math dot
floor, chars to show divided by
two. And if you don't understand
this math here, don't worry
about it. And then we're gonna
say return full string
substring of zero to front chars
plus the SEP IRA tour plus full
STR dot substring. of full STR
dot length, minus back chars.
And now what we can do is we can
grab this truncate STR this
truncate string and for is
formatted seller will say if
it's you will still do you but
otherwise we'll do truncate
string of seller or blank if
there's no seller, and we'll
have it be size 15. And now if
we save that, go back to our
front end, if it's owned by you,
it's still gonna say on by you.
But if we switch accounts, and
now says owned by, you know,
blah, blah, blah, dot the dot
blah, blah, blah with a
truncated address. And then
these sizes don't actually
change, which is a lot nicer
than them getting bigger and
smaller. So awesome. So now we
have this formatted even better.
Okay, now what do we want to do?
Well, now that we know who owns
the NFT, NF T, and it's
formatted pretty nicely, we need
to figure out a way to update
the listing. So what we want to
do is, once again, if it's owned
by us, and we can switch back to
the account, it's owned by if
it's owned by us, when we click
on it, we want to be able to
update the listing on the
marketplace. So to do this,
we're going to create a new
component called Update listing
ngModel. So we're gonna create a
new component, new file, update,
listing ngmodel.js. A ngModel is
something that like pops up. So
for example,
this little pop up here is known
as a modal. And this is what we
want to build. If it's owned by
us, when we click this, we want
it to pop up this modal thing.
So to get started, we'll do the
same thing we've been doing for
all of our components here,
we'll do export default,
function, update, listing
ngModel, like so. And we're
probably going to want to pass
it these parameters from the
entity box, probably gonna want
to pass these parameters. So the
ngModel knows what function it
needs to call in our NFT
marketplace. The way we're going
to update listing is we're going
to call this update listing
function where we need the
address token ID and then some
new price. So we're going to at
least need those. So we're going
to need the NFT address, and at
least the token ID to make this
little pop up, we're not going
to code it ourselves, we're
going to once again, use the web
three UI kit, web three UI Kit
has this nice pop up section,
where it has some code to work
with a modal. So we're going to
import that will do import
ngModel from web three UI kit,
like so here's what it looks
like we have modal and then we
have all this stuff on working
with the modal. So we'll do our
return, do a little modal, like
this. One of the key things in a
ngModel is whether or not it
should be visible. So it has an
is visible tag, which we're
actually gonna have to grab,
we're actually gonna have to
grab from the empty box. So
we're going to pass a little is
visible here as well, in our NFT
box, we need to tell our ngModel
when it's visible. So we'll
we'll make that code in a little
bit. Right now, it'll just be
blank. And inside of our
ngModel, we're going to want to
give an input field for how to
update it. So I know we've done
some regular inputs before,
since we've been working with
web through UI kit, let's just
use the input that it has as
well. So we'll do a little comma
input here. And inside of the
ngModel we'll create a new
input. So on our input field,
we'll give this a label which is
going to be update listing price
in L one currency. And we'll
just do eath. For now we'll just
hard coded as eath name will be
new listing price, and type is
going to equal a number we'll do
Little backslash here, oops,
we'll do a little backslash
instead of like that. So cool.
So when this modal pops up, it's
gonna have this input in here.
And we can actually test to see
if this is working. We can
import this into our NFT box,
we'll do import, update, listing
ngModel. From that slash,
update, listing ngModel oops,
and sorry, this doesn't need
parentheses, and at the top of
our return here, right before
our card will add it in. So
we'll just add another div
though. So that these two can be
in the same react. But we'll add
another div, we'll say Update
listing ngModel, like so with a
little backslash here. And right
now we just have to pass is
visible. And then for now, we're
just going to say true. So now
with this listing ngModel on our
front end, we do a little
refresh. And we get this little
box like this update listing
price and one currency. And we
have to close two of them.
Because technically we right now
both modalities are true, right.
So if we do a refresh, we get
this little input pop up this
little modal and we close it
twice, because we have two NF
T's if you have a ton of NF T's
here, you will have to close a
ton of those. So we change it to
false, we go back to the front
end, we do a little refresh, and
boom, now it's false. So true,
save, run, and it's there.
Gross, delete, delete, false,
save front end, it's not there
anymore. Okay, cool. So we're
gonna have to tell this ngModel
only to pop up when somebody
clicks this and have tea that
they own. So to actually toggle
this and actually make this
work, we're going to update our
card. So whenever we click our
card, we're going to create a
function called handle card
click that handle card click is
going to update a variable for
whether or not we should show
this ngModel. So we're going to
do is we're gonna say on click
of the card, aka, once we click
our dog, we're going to call
some function. So we're gonna
say on click, equals handle
card, click, animal card, click,
and we're going to make this a
function, we're gonna say const,
handle card click equals a
function, we'll use some Arrow
stuff here. And then we'll just
say, if it's is owned by user,
if it's on by user, we'll show
the ngModel. Else, we will call
the by item function, since we
want our whole UI to rerender.
Once we change, once we change
the variable to show the
ngModel, we're going to do this
as a US state. So we'll say
const, show ngModel. Come a set,
show ngModel equals use state.
And then we're going to start it
off being defaulted to false. So
by default, we are not going to
show them on down which is what
we want. But if it's owned by
the user, we're gonna say Set
Show ngModel to be true. And
then else right now we'll just
put console dot log, let's buy
will actually update this to
bind the item a little bit
later. So now instead of having
is visible be false, we'll have
is visible equal to show
ngModel. Or show ngModel.
Variable. Okay, great. So now if
we save that, we go back to our
UI, we right click, we hit
Inspect, if we own it, and we
click it, the ngModel will pop
up, and we can click it out,
click another one, but that will
pop up if we don't own it. So if
we switch accounts, Connect will
switch. We click it, nothing
happens. And if we go to
inspect, we go to the console,
we click it, we should see let's
buy pop up, which is what we do
see, we'll do a little refresh
here. Click we see let's buy pop
up, click again, let's buy click
let's pilots pilots, why? Great,
cool. So now we have a word for
that ngModel. To actually show
up correctly, let's switch back
to the person who actually owns
this NFT we click it, we want to
be able to when we hit OK, or
submit, we want to send a
transaction to update the price
of our NFT here, so what we can
do is in our input will have a
label called on change equals
and this is the function that
will call whenever this updates.
So we're gonna say on change
event is going to be a function.
And we're going to create a
function called set price to
update listing listing with
event dot target dot value. So
we want to keep track of
whatever we've put in here. So
when we call the function to
update the price, it'll just
already automatically have it.
So we'll create this function
and event dot target dot value
is going to be whatever's in
this input box here. So we'll
create this set price to update
listing with will have this be a
use date because we are going to
want to change the UI based off
this so we'll say const price to
up date listing with comma set
price to update listing with
equals use state and then we'll
have this be zero to start or
blank. And so now, whatever is
in here is going to get updated
with this. So now I can do like
our console dot log price update
listing with Get back to the
front end, oops, we need to
import use state import, use
state from react. Go back to the
front end, we click this, we
right click Inspect.
By type one, we can see 114, we
see 14. So let's remove the
console dot log now. Now what we
can do in here is we can create
field called on okay, this is
going to be the function that we
call when we hit this, okay
here, so on. Okay, it's going to
be equal to a function, we're
going to use a little arrow
notation, and we're going to
call that update listing
function on the blockchain,
we're going to need to grab that
function so we can use it. So
once again, to use that
function, we're going to import
use web three contract from
react mirallas. And as a new
hook, we'll say const run
contract function called Update
listing, equals use web three
contract. And this is going to
be a function that we're going
to call on our NFT marketplace.
So ABI is going to be the NFT
marketplace API, which we can
get by doing an import, similar
to what we did over here. And we
actually just copy paste from
our NFT box. So we'll do import
NFT marketplace API from dot dot
constant send it to marketplace
that JSON, we're gonna need the
contract address, which is going
to be an input parameter to our
update listing ngModel. So we
can even do a comma market place
address, copy this place that
here, that means in our NFT box,
pretty soon, we're going to have
to pass all these variables to
it, but we'll save that in just
a second. So NFT marketplace
address marketplace address
function name, is going to be
what it's called Update, listing
in our smart contract, and then
the params. So if we go to this,
we have update listing takes the
NFT address token ID and new
price do NFT address, which will
be NFT address, we'll say token
ID is going to be token ID and
the new price your price will
get from price to update listing
with but will convert it from
human readable to ethers. So
we'll import ethers from ethers.
And the new price will be ethers
dot utils dot parse ethers or
ether price to update listing
with or just in case it's blank,
we'll just say or zero. So we
have the NFT address the token
ID marketplace address in our
NFT box, we're gonna have to
pass those parameters in here.
So we have is visible, we're
also going to have token ID,
which is going to equal token
ID, marketplace address is going
to equal the marketplace
address. And the NFT address is
going to equal the NFT address.
And as we code and test this
something that's going to be
really annoying, because it's
really annoying for me right now
let's refresh our website. And
if we click it, this thing pops
up. But when I hit X, and I
click this, again, nothing shows
up. That's because technically
show ngModel is still true right
now, even though we've exited
out. So what we want to do in
the NFT box is in our update
listing ngModel we're also going
to pass it in on close, and
we're going to pass it a hide
ngModel variable that we're
going to create, and right under
Show ngModel Set Show ngModel
we're going to create const Eid
ngModel. And this is just going
to be a function, that's just
going to say set, show modal. to
false, we're going to pass this
function to our update modal
listing. So we're going to do
comma on Close. And in our modal
here, we're going to say, on
Close. On, cancel, we're going
to do, we're going to call that
on close function, or on Close
button pressed, we're also going
to call that on close function.
Now if we refresh our website,
click this modal pops up, we
click X, click it again, it'll
pop back up, because now we're
properly setting it to false and
then resetting it to true. Now
to actually send this update
listing function, we're going to
pass this another thing, another
variable, we're going to pass it
on Okay, which is going to be a
function as well. It's just
going to call update listing
that we just created. Now, it's
always a good idea to add an On
error. We'd say on error, take
that error as a function and
console dot log.
The error and this needs to be
in squiggly brackets like that,
but contract address is wrong.
So we'll make this contract, con
tract address and spell that
correctly. Spelled correctly.
Now let's go back to the UI,
we'll give it a little refresh.
Click, this will add one. And we
see Metamask pop up. So this is
working out perfectly. Now I'm
going to cancel it, and our apps
gonna freak out and stuff. But
that's okay, we are doing
fantastically okay app popped up
like that, which is good. We
have this little error handling,
which I like to add for all of
these run contract functions.
Let's also do an on success. So
let's say when this does go
through successfully, we'll call
a function called handle update,
listing success. And this will
be a function that we'd call
when this goes through
correctly. So at the top, let's
make this new function, we'll
say const. Handle update,
listening success is going to be
a new function using the arrow
syntax here. And we'll have this
setup a new notification for a
web application. So for us to do
notifications, we're going to
use web three UI Kits use
notification, this is going to
be that same notification
service that we used in our last
one. So up at the top here,
we'll import it, use
notification. And then we'll
say, right in our component,
we'll say const, dispatch equals
use notification. And since
we're using notifications back
on our app.js, we have to import
it in here. So we'll do import
notification provider from web
three UI kit. And inside of our
Morales provider, we'll add the
notification provider around our
header and our component, so
that we have context for this.
Now in our handle update listing
success, inside this function
will say dispatch, say type is
going to be success. message
will be listing updated, title
will be listing updated, please
refresh, please refresh and move
blocks. And then position. Top
right. And then we'll do on
clothes, and on clothes. And
we'll say set price to update
listing with back to zero. I
also I'm editing this a little
bit in the future. And I
realized that I actually forgot
to add the TX to a lot of these
handle functions. So on these,
whenever we call one of these
run contract functions, like
we've been saying they have this
on error in this onsuccess. Now
this onsuccess automatically
passes the result of the call to
whatever callback function is
there. So for example, up the
listing returns a transaction,
and we'll pass that transaction
to whatever you add to the
onsuccess. So now in here, you
can actually have it have a
transaction as an input
parameter. And this would be the
transaction that's going to go
on the blockchain to you know,
update the price. So we actually
want to change it from a regular
function to an async function.
So we can actually do await TX
dot Wait, one, because we don't
want to say, hey, success, you
know, listing has been updated
before the transaction actually
goes through. So we want the
transaction to go through first.
And then we want to pop the
dispatch up saying, hey, it's
gone through so and then
additionally, when we actually
call these modells on the on,
okay, on the onsuccess, we pass
them in just by referencing the
name of the function. So we
don't do this arrow syntax,
anymore like this, we just say,
hey, the onsuccess is going to
be this, go ahead and pass your
results to it. So that's how we
actually call it down here. If
you look at the GitHub repo
associated with this, you go to
components, and we go into
these. So in this video, I
forgot to add the await TX dot
wait one. But in the GitHub
repo, we have these. And when
I'm demoing things in the video
here, the dispatch, it's gonna
pop up before the transaction
actually finishes going through.
So just want to let you know,
and back to the video. So now we
have a little success thing
that'll pop up when we're
successful. And the other thing
is, when we call this, we are
going to omit an item listed
inside of our Morales dashboard,
the price should actually update
in our active item because of
our Cloud Functions. So we're
going to put this all together
now. So we're on the front end.
And if the marketplace owned by
you will click it. Update
listing to 25. We're gonna hit
OK, meta masks is gonna pop up.
We're gonna go ahead and confirm
and ran through an error because
we need to click Metamask I need
to reset my account. So I'm
going to do settings, advanced
reset account.
Okay, now let's go ahead
Metamask has popped up again,
we're gonna go ahead and confirm
it closed, the pop up modal, and
we got our little notification
there. And we can see an
activity we have that
transaction has indeed completed
So now if we go to active item,
we give it a little refresh.
Right now we see our item listed
event. But the issue is that
it's not confirmed yet. So what
we're going to need to do is
we're going to need to move our
blocks by one. So in our NFT
marketplace, we're just going to
create a new script, a new file
called Mind dot Jas, just to
move our blocks once, and we're
going to say const, move blocks,
equals require dot slash utils,
slash move blocks, we'll say
const blocks equals to const
sleep amount equals 1000 async
function mine, do await move
blocks will do blocks as the
parameter and then sleep sleep
amount will equal sleep amount.
And this will be a script. So
we'll add our copy paste our
that same syntax we're doing
here just with mine. And now we
want to just mine these two
blocks. So we'll run yarn, art
hat run scripts. Mind that Jas
dash dash network, local host.
So we're going to mine those two
blocks. Now if we go back to our
database, we go back to active
items, we can see it's been
updated because now in our item
listed, that 2500 event is now a
confirmed transaction, and we
get to confirm their excellent.
So that means since it's
confirmed back in our front end,
we'll give this a little
refresh. We can see the pup is
now worth 25 eath. Awesome. So
we're updating ngModel is
working perfectly. Excellent
job. So now let's go to the
readme. If you own the NFT, you
can update the listing. That's a
checkmark. Excellent. Next, what
do we want it to do? If you
don't own it, you can buy the
listing. Okay, so let's go back
to our website, let's switch
users to a different account,
we're probably going to want an
account that own some money. So
let's go ahead and send this
other account some money
transfer between my accounts,
we'll send 100 eath to account
one, confirm on our hard hat
chain here. Alright, great. Now
we can go ahead and switch to
account one, and we have 100
eath. Okay, great. As these
pops, each cost less than 100
eath. So that's gonna be more
than plenty for us to test this
out. Let's go back to this box.
Because I think somewhere we
said, we did a little handle
card click, if it's owned by the
user, have the modal pop up. If
not, let's do the by
functionality. So to do the by
functionality, we're gonna go
ahead and do another run
contract function. So we'll do
const run contract function,
we'll call this one by item. And
this will equal use web three
contract. And this is going to
be the ABI for the NFT
marketplace. API, the contract
address is going to be the
market place address. The
function name is going to be by
item, the message value is going
to be the price of the NFT.
Because we need to send that
amount to buy the item. And then
params are going to be NFT
address, which is going to be
the NFT address. And the token
ID, which is going to be the
token ID now that we have this
by item on handle card click, we
can say okay, said show ngModel
is true. Otherwise, we're gonna
call by item. And we're going to
do on air. Air is going to be a
function where we're just going
to console dot log the air and
onsuccess. It'll be a function
where we call handle by item
success. So we'll create a new
handler for this right
underneath handled cart click
the const handled by item
success equals a function. And
for this, we'll also have this
do a little notification. So
once again, we're going to
import we're going to import use
notification from web through UI
kit. We're going to say const.
Dispatch equals use
notification. And then in
handled by item success. We're
gonna say dispatch
type, success. Message. Item
bought. Title will also be item
bought. Then pole position will
be top right That's it. So
handle card click, if they own
it, we're going to show that
update listing ngModel. If they
don't already own it, someone's
gonna buy it. So let's go back
here. And I'm currently on an
account that does not own these
NF T's. Let's go ahead and click
it. Our Metamask does indeed
show up for 25 eath. That's
crazy expensive. Let's go ahead
and confirm item has been
bought, we'll go ahead and click
that little x, we go to our meta
mask, the transaction is
pending. And it's gone through.
This is fantastic. Okay, our
homepage is done, we can show
recently listed NF T's if not,
you can update the listing. If
not, you can buy the listing.
And now it's time for our cell
page. So the last thing that we
need to do is our cell page,
let's get this cell page, let's
get this done pages, we have our
cell NFT page, which right now
does a whole lot of nothing. And
on our front end, we go here,
there's not a whole lot here.
And actually, you can list your
NFT in the marketplace, we also
needed to add withdraw proceeds.
So I didn't add that. But that's
probably going to be something
we're going to want to allow
people to do as well. So let's
get started here. So we can
remove this head stuff now that
we're adding that in our main
page. And for us to submit a new
NFT, we're probably gonna need a
space to add the address of the
entity that token ID of the NFT
and all this other stuff. So
we're gonna need a form to do
this, which guess what, we can
also grab a form from the web
through UI kit as well. So we're
gonna go ahead in our cell NMC
page, we're going to import form
from web three UI kit. And we're
going to create a new form in
our cell page. Now, the
parameters we can add to our
form, again, you can find them
in documentation here, or we're
going to add with one of the
main pieces is going to be this
data piece, which is going to be
an object that has a list in it,
of all the different fields, we
can put in our form. So maybe
we'll do our first one have a
name of NFT address. That's
gonna be of type text, excuse
me, and these are all going to
be this is a list of list of
objects like that. Now, if we
save that, we go back to our
cell page, we can now see an
empty address and a little
Submit button. That right now
does a whole lot of nothing. So
we have an NFT address, it'll
take a text, maybe we'll also do
in foot width of 50 percent will have
the starting value be blank. And
the key of this will be NFT
address, what else do we need,
we're going to need to give it
the token ID so we'll say name,
token ID, type is going to be a
number value, we'll start off
it's blank. And then the key for
this will be token ID. Next,
we're going to need the price.
So we'll say name will be price.
In eath. type will be a number
value will be blank. And the key
will be price. And we don't need
to have to form tags, we'll just
delete that second one and have
it auto close with one tag. And
then in here, we'll do title
equals sell your NF T ID equals
main form. So cool. So now we
can take an empty address, a
token ID and a new price with
the title of cellular NFT.
Great, that looks really nice.
Right now our form doesn't do
anything, we probably want to
give it the functionality to
actually do stuff. So we'll say
on Submit, and we'll have to
create a new function to
actually list our NF T's. So
we're going to create a function
called approve and list we have
to approve our marketplace to
pull the NFT from our wallets.
So we're going to create a new
function, a sync function
approven list, which is going to
take a data input parameter on
our form, when we hit on submit,
it's automatically going to pass
this data object to our approved
list function. So that's how
we're going to get the value of
the address the value of the
token ID and the value of the
price. So in our async function
approven list, do console dot
log, approving the contract, the
NFT address is going to come
from this data object. So it's
going to be data dot data at
index zero, or zero with object
here is going to be our address
that input result.
Our token ID is going to equal
data dot data. One because
again, this one is going to be
our token ID that input result.
And then the price is going to
equal that ethers dot utils dot
parse units of data dot data
have to the input result, comma
ether.to string. So we're going
to get the price in eath. In
human readable form, we're going
to convert it to Aetherium
readable form. And then we're
going to pass it as a string
because this returns a big
number, which we don't want. So
we have the NFT address, the
token ID and the price of the
new listing, what we can do now
is we can say const approve
options equals a little function
here, the ABI which is going to
be our NFT abi, which we need to
import, we need to import both
ethers from ethers. And we also
need to import the NFT abi, for
its NFT ABI from dot dot
constants slash basic at A T dot
JSON, I just copied and pasted
from the NFT box, the contract
address is going to be the NFT
address, the function name is
going to be approve params are
going to be two, the marketplace
address, which we're going to
define in just a second, and
then the token ID will be token
ID. Now the marketplace address
in our NFT box, we're getting
this directly from index, an
index is getting it from our
database. Now we want our app to
be smart enough to be able to
grab the NFT marketplace itself,
the marketplace address. And if
we go to our constants, right
now, we actually have it in this
network mapping. So we're going
to want to grab it right up at
the top by saying const
marketplace address equals
network mapping, network mapping
of what of the chain ID of the
entity marketplace address at
the zero with index. So network
mapping of the chain ID, which
we're going to get honest chain
ID equals us Morales. Now chain
Id actually comes like we said
it's a wax hex form for Morales.
So we're gonna have to convert
the chain ID to its string
readable version. So we'll say
const, chain string equals chain
ID. And we'll do a tertiary
operator, if the chain ID
exists, will parse int of the
chain id.to string. So we'll
parse it from its hex to a more
readable version, and then do.to
string. And then otherwise,
we'll just say we're on 31337.
So chain ID string. So in the
network mapping at the chain ID
string, dot NFT marketplace at
index zero, that's going to be
our marketplace address. So we
got the marketplace address,
this is all we need to call the
approved function on our NFT we
can now call running contract
function for a proof. So we're
actually going to do this a
little bit differently. We're
just going to say const. Run
contract function equals use web
three contract, you could import
just run contract function, and
then pass all those options to
it like what we're gonna do
here. Now we're just gonna say
await on contract function.
Because this is an async
function await run contract
function, we're gonna say params
are going to be approve options.
And we're gonna say onsuccess,
we're going to do something, I'm
going to say on error, we're
also going to just do error,
little arrow function, console
dot log error. Now on success,
once we send this transaction,
after the Approve goes through,
we're going to want to call the
list function right underneath
this will call async async.
Function, handle approve
success. And this is going to
take the NFT address, the token
ID, and the price is it put in
parameters. So once this run
contract function goes through,
we're going to call
of handle proof success. And
we'll pass it the end of the
address, token ID and the price,
which will say console dot log.
Okay, now time to list and we'll
do the same thing. We'll do
const list options, equals and
this is going to be all the
options for calling the list
function API is going to be on
the marketplace this time. So
NFT market place abi, which
again, we're going to have to
import so I'm going to go back
to NFT box. We're gonna copy
that line here, paste it in the
top. That's going to be the API
for that contract address. It's
going to be the marketplace
address, which we already have.
function name is going to be
list item. And the params are
going to be NF T address of the
NFT address, token ID of token
ID, price of price. And now we
have those options, we can do
await, run contract function
with params. Of list options,
will say onsuccess arrow
function, handle list success,
which is a function we haven't
made yet. It will say on air
error. And we'll just say
console dot log error. Okay, so
let's make this handle list
success handle one spell handle
correctly handle the success,
this will be an async function.
And this is also going to call
dispatch and make a little
notification. So we're going to
grab that from web three UI kit,
use notification. We'll say
const dispatch equals use
notification. And now down in
handle the success say dispatch,
type success. Message NFT
listing, title NFT listed
position. top bar, and cool. And
we're also gonna have to grab us
Morales from react Morales. So
do import us Morales from react
or else. So let's import this
network mapping. Import network
mapping from dot dot slash
constants slash network mapping
dot JSON. Because I spelled
contract address wrong again,
good our front end we'll give it
a refresh us web three contract
isn't defined. Let's get that
from react moralss. Well save
that refresh our front end. And
tada, we're good to go here.
Alright, now to test this out,
we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to create
another script here. So we're
back in our heart at NFT
marketplace, we're looking at
our scripts. And we're going to
create a new file just called
mint.js. So we're not going to
list this time, we're just going
to mint it just going to mint an
NF t so we can list it ourselves
on the UI. And actually, we can
just copy our mminton list code,
paste it into here, and just
remove the approval and the
listing code. Boom, remove that,
remove this, remove this. And
that's all we need. And now
we'll just change the name to
mint. Well, we can remove price
as well. And we'll change this
to mint. And that's it. Now we
have a script that we can call,
well, we'll just mint an NFT, we
can also get rid of the NFT
marketplace. Actually, we will
probably want the token ID so we
can know what it is. So let's do
const token ID equals. So let's
actually get the receipt we'll
do const mint TX receipt, but
the receipt, I can there equals
that. And then I'm just going to
copy this from the mminton
receipt. Cons token ID equals
this, paste it into our mint.js
and then a console dot log. Got
token ID, string interpolates
token ID, hard hat, run scripts,
mins dot j s dash dash network,
local host. And we're going to
mint an NF T. Got token ID six
means we know m token ID six, we
can list this entity. Let's also
add the address. Let's do
console dot log NFTL. And if the
address is going to be we'll do
string interpolation.
And you know what? Let's make
this again. Mint dot j s okay
cool. Got token ID seven and if
the address this so what we can
do now we'll grab this NFT
address. So from account one,
let's go to Account three
because that's the account that
I've done my imports on now when
you switch accounts, we're going
to want to refresh the page as
the address seven 0.6. Submit
Metamask pops up. Give
permission Yes. Okay, now it's
time to list you now have one
pen, okay. Local host list item.
We can see all the data and
everything. Okay, let's go ahead
and confirm NFT listed Okay,
okay. Okay. Okay. So this is
good. Now to get Morales to
catch up to speed back in our
node. Let's just go ahead and
run yarn, RT hat run scripts,
mine dot j s dash dash network,
local host. We're going to mine
those two blocks. And now if we
go to our item listed, we'll
give this a little refresh. Go
to active item. We can see
there's a new item listed for
0.6 eath. In our database. This
is fantastic. Now that we've
listed this, if we go back to
now let's make And let's move on
to one more. Let's list the
second one, just to see that
it's actually working. Okay,
token ID eight. Let's grab this
address. Let's give this a
refresh. paste this in token ID
eight. We'll do 0.999. Let's
submit. we'll approve this. Yes.
Then we'll send it. Yes. Okay,
now let's go ahead and mine two
blocks. So I'm just going to hit
up and go back to mine will run
the mining, moving blocks. Okay,
great. Now, if we go back home,
we'll see there are three NF T's
now listed, we have the original
one, that we have those two that
we just listed eight, and seven
for 0.6 and 0.999. Listed on our
NFT marketplace. This is so
exciting. Our listing is working
correctly, okay. Now, due to the
fact that this lesson is already
incredibly long, actually
decided to cut the part of that
and then withdraw a bit, because
we don't really learn anything
new there. However, feel free to
jump back in to get every bit
associated with scores, where we
will have that withdrawal
functionality for you if you
want to implement it. Otherwise,
feel free to skip and move on
ahead. This is incredibly
powerful. And you should be
incredibly excited about
yourself. If you've made it this
far. This is awesome. You just
made a decentralized marketplace
and then built a front end on
top of it to allow anybody to
interact with your marketplace.
Easily. Huge, huge.
Congratulations here. Oh, this
is a perfect time to go take a
break and celebrate. And this is
a great time to ping me on
Twitter to ping me on Twitter
saying hey, Patrick, I just
completed the NFT marketplace.
Full Stack front end part of
your Free Code Camp course, I
now know how to build full stack
front end on top of my smart
contract applications. And be so
so pumped with yourself because
this is so awesome. I can't
understate how excited I am that
you've made it this far, you are
learning and working with a ton
of technologies, solidity smart
contracts, and front end you are
doing full stack you were doing
a lot of stuff here. So you
should be really proud of
yourself. huge congratulations,
be sure to absolutely give
yourself a pat on the back. And
then get ready to continue to
our next section.
Now that we've done all of this
using our Morales back end, I'm
about to switch it up on you,
instead of indexing all of our
events with a centralized
server. Now we're going to learn
how to build this using the
graph, which is a decentralized
event indexer that we can use, a
lot of the code is going to be
exactly the same. So instead of
us starting from a new, what
we're going to do, first of all
we can we can close all our
local stuff, we can close all of
these things, we can close all
of our terminals finally, which
is really exciting. And in this
folder, what we're going to do
is we're actually just going to
copy everything into a new
folder. So I'm going to CD down
a directory, we're going to make
a new one called next Jas. And
if T marketplace, the graph,
dash FCC, and all the code for
this section is going to be here
for front end the graph indexer
we're gonna have to make another
repo and we'll get to that in a
little bit. For all the changes,
it's going to be in this section
here. So what we're going to do
is we're going to make this new
folder, and we're going to do
copy dash R. Next, Jas and ft
marketplace FCC into next Jas
NFT. Marketplace, the graph FCC.
So we're going to copy
recursively, everything that's
inside that folder we just
created into this new one that
we're going to make a lot of
adjustments to. And this might
take a little bit of time to run
because we've got a lot of stuff
in this folder. And Alright,
once we've done that, we can cd
into this next Jas and ft
marketplace, the graph FCC and
do code period and open this up
in a new code editor. Or as
always, you can do File Open
folder to open it like that. Now
that we're in here, we're going
to learn how to do this exact
same project, instead of using
mirallas. But using the graph,
one of the things that we're
first going to do is we're
actually going to deploy our
contracts to rink B. So we're
going to grab our marketplace,
that soul, pull this over, we're
going to grab our hard hat
marketplace dot soul project,
pull it over. And first, we're
going to run our deploy script
on rink v. So hopefully, you've
got all your deploy stuff set up
correctly, so that all the
arguments can go through
correctly for rink v as well. So
we're gonna go ahead and run
this yarn, hard hat deploy dash
dash network Rinkeby. And to
make sure that it's going to
work for Rinkeby. Let's check
our hard hat config. Okay for
networks, looks like I have my
Rigby stuff in here for
networks. Okay, I've got my RPC
URL, which I'm getting from my
environment variables. If I have
a private key, I have a private
key, which I'm also getting from
environment variables, I have a
chain ID block confirmations and
save deployments. So let's go
ahead and run this. Now we're
going to go ahead and be
deploying the NFT marketplace to
the Rigby network. And our
deploy script also has an ID
some verification. So we can
verify this as well, you can't
really follow along with this
section without deploying a
marketplace to rink be here. So
deploy to rank B, or whatever
test net is recommended in this
lesson 15 section, and go from
there. Alright, great, we've
deployed our NFC marketplace.
Now we're gonna go ahead and
deploy our basic NFT. And once
these are done deploying, we can
start updating our front end
code to work with the graph
instead of mirallas. Okay, we've
verified everything to which
looks great. Now we're going to
verify our basic NFT. And we've
have it verified. Awesome. So
now we have an NFT marketplace
deployed to ring P, and a basic
NFT deployed to rink B. And both
of them are verified. So be sure
to take note of those, because
we're going to need them when
we're moving over to our the
graph section. So now let's grab
our code editor titled next Jas
and ft marketplace, the graph.
And let's get going. Now, we
just deployed that to rink B.
But we forgot to add some code
in here to update our network
mapping. However, if we go back
and we open back up code dot
dot, next Jas NFT marketplace,
FCC, in the network mapping in
here will now have a new entry
for rink B, if we did it
correctly, let's copy this
network mapping and paste it
over in our network, our next GS
and ft marketplace, the graph
section, or you can just
manually add your new entry.
Right. So you want to add
network ID for network
marketplace. And the address of
that network marketplace that
you just deployed, is we're
going to delete this Cloud
Functions bit. Goodbye, because
since we're not working with the
server anymore, there's not
gonna be any cloud functions or
any back end to run. So we're
gonna move that to trash
goodbye. Next, we don't need FRP
anymore, because we're not going
to be connecting our local
blockchain to the graph, we're
only going to be working with
the test net here. So let's go
ahead and delete that. Goodbye,
what's next in our pages, and
our app dot j s. Right now we're
connecting to a Morales provider
like this, we're going to switch
this back to initiate allies on
Mount, this is going to go back
to being false, we're no longer
going to connect to our Morales
database like this, we're just
going to use the hooks again.
Now with that the only thing
that's going to change is our
index.js. Right now, in our
index.js, we're getting our list
of NF TS from our Morales query.
So we're going to change this,
let's update our readme. So
we're gonna say instead of
reading the events from ralis,
we will first off we're going to
index them with the graph. And
then we're going to read from
the graph. So the question is,
what is the graph.
So the graph is going to be a
decentralized layer for storing
event data. So there are all
these blockchains and all these
different storage networks. And
the graph is and the graph is a
network of different nodes that
read from blockchains and index
this data, and it exposes an API
for us to call we can read that
data. Rather than just myself.
We actually have nattered
Abbott, who can explain it a lot
better than I can take it away.
And at.
First, I'd like to thank Patrick
for creating such a wonderful
educational resource and
inviting me to be a part of it.
My name is Nadia dabit. I'm a
developer relations engineer
working with the graph. The
graph is an indexing and
querying protocol for
decentralized networks like
Aetherium IPFS, dozens of other
EVM compatible networks, as well
as near and then the future
cosmos and Solana. Using the
graph developers can build and
publish open API's called
subgraphs that they can then use
in their applications to enable
better querying capabilities of
data stored on these networks,
including features like
filtering, sorting, relational
data, and full stack search.
subgraphs live in between the
blockchain and the UI providing
an important piece of software
infrastructure, a flexible
performant and decentralized API
layer, and the traditional tech
stack databases, servers and
API's query filter, sort
paginate group and join data
before it's returned to an
application, usually via some
type of HTTP request. These
types of data transformations
are not possible when reading
data directly from Aetherium or
other blockchains. Before the
graph teams had to develop and
operate proprietary indexing
servers. This required
significant engineering and
hardware resources and broke the
important security principles
required for decentralization,
how we interact with and build
on top of blockchains it's much
different than what we are used
to in the traditional tech
stack. In a blockchain data
isn't stored in a format that
can be easily or efficiently
consumed, or retrieved directly
from other applications or front
ends. The problem is that you
need to have the data indexed
and organized for efficient
retrieval. Traditionally, that's
the work that databases and web
servers do in this centralized
tech stack. But that in indexing
layer was missing in the web
three stack. Let's take a look
at a couple of other examples of
indexing in the real world.
Search engines like Google crawl
the internet indexing relevant
data making it available for
users to search via their web
interface and other API's.
Without this indexing layer,
it'd be hard for us to know
where and how to find relevant
information across the web.
Another similar analogy is a
library. Using an indexing
system like the Dewey Decimal
System, we know where to find
the book that we're looking for
without having to go through
book by book looking throughout
the entire library. The graph
serves over 2 billion queries
per day to many different types
of web three applications,
including apps in the defy
gaming and FC space. Before we
dig into any code, let's take a
look at how to build a sub
graph. To get started, you would
go to the graph.com and create a
new sub graph and the graph user
interface. You would then use
the graph CLI to scaffold out an
empty sub graph boilerplate that
you can then update with your
own contract information. In
your subgraph configuration, you
would define things like your
data model, the network, the
contract addresses and other
configurations that are specific
to the data that you would like
to index. For our data model, we
use Graph QL, schema definition
language defining top level
types as well as fields within
those types. When we're ready to
deploy our subgraph, so we can
begin testing it out and using
it in our application, we can
use the graph CLI running the
deploy command. Once the
subgraph is deployed and the
data begins to be indexed, we
can start testing it out using
the graphical interface directly
in the graph dashboard. When
we're ready to start queering,
our sub graph from our
application, we can use the API
URL that's been given to us by
the graph along with any Graph
QL query. If you'd like to learn
more about the graph, check out
the graph.com as well as Graph
Protocol, Twitter, the docs at
the graph.com/docs, or our
Discord at the graph.com/discord
Thanks matter. And now that we
have a better idea of what the
graph is, we can actually start
building with it. Now if we were
to try to run this app as it is,
it obviously would fail, right,
because index.js, right now is
reading from mirallas instead of
from the graph. So like it says
in our readme, first thing we're
going to need to do is we're
gonna need to index from the
graph, and then we can just this
project to read from the graph.
So let's go ahead and learn how
to build our sub graph. In order
for us to tell the graph network
to start indexing the events
from our contract, we're gonna
go to graph.com, we're gonna go
to products. And we're going to
go to sub graph studio, if you
go to products, the first thing
you see is the Graph Explorer,
these are already existing sub
graphs. And if you go through
here, you'll see a lot of
incredibly popular decentralized
protocols all have different sub
graphs, hosted service is going
to get discontinued at some
point. So we're going to skip
there. So let's go to sub graph
studio, this is going to help
enable us to create a sub graph
for other nodes to start
indexing our events. So we're
gonna go ahead and connect our
wallet with meta mask. And I'm
going to choose account one
here, next connect, and we're
going to want to switch off of
Hardhead. Local, over to the
Rinkeby test network. And I'll
go to Account one here. And
we're going to get a signature
request from the graph summary
to the website that we just
built. The subgraph website has
some signings functionality with
a database on the back end. So
we're seeing in real life,
exactly the methods that we just
used. So instead of signing with
Morales, they're just have their
own custom sign in here. So
we're gonna go ahead and sign in
so that the graph website knows
that it can interact with us.
And we can go ahead and enter
our email if we want. I'm gonna
go ahead and skip. And you'll
even get a little notification
here saying only subgraphs
indexing Aetherium or main net
or Rigby can be created in
subgraph studio. So let's go
ahead and create a subgraph. So
we're going to pick a cerium
Rigby and the subgraph name is
going to be NFT marketplace.
We'll go ahead and hit Continue.
Now, this is going to be our
dashboard for creating our sub
graph. And there's a ton of
instructions over here and
documentation that we can view
to get started, I'm going to add
this documentation to the GitHub
repo associated with this
course. So this NFT marketplace
sub graph is going to need its
own git repository itself. So
what we're going to do back in
here is we're going to CD down,
we're going to make a new
directory, and we're going to
call it graph. And if T
marketplace, FCC, we're going to
open that up as well. So code
graph NFT, marketplace, FCC, or
file open graft code marketplace
FCC, and in this window, we're
going to build our subgraph.
Locally, we're going to build
our subgraph and push it up to
the subgraph studio. And in
here, there's a whole bunch of
instructions that we can follow
along with to go ahead and
install. The first thing that we
need to do is install the graph
command line interface. And we
want to install this globally.
So I'm going to copy this part
here. Come back to my terminal
Oh, yarn, global ad and paste
that in. It's this command line
that's going to help us build a
graph and build instructions for
the graph to actually start
indexing our events. Now that
we've installed the globally, we
can initialize our graph code.
So we can copy this line. And
we'll run graph a knit dash dash
studio NFT marketplace and hit
enter. The protocol is going to
be Aetherium, or subgraph. Slug
will be NFT. marketplace. We
want the directory to be here,
but it's saying directory
already exists. So we'll just
give it NFT marketplace. And
then we'll move it after this.
And this is on the Rinkeby. Test
net. And now we want to give it
the contract address. So we want
to grab that address that we
just deployed. And it should be
now in our network mapping. So
we're going to grab that
contract address that we just
deployed, and paste it in here.
Like so. And since we've already
verified on ether scan, it
automatically grabs the ABI for
us from ether scan, we'll give
it the contract name, which is
the NFT marketplace. And it's
going to give us a whole bunch
of boilerplate code in this NFT
marketplace directory. And this
might take a couple of minutes.
Alright, awesome. So now that
it's done, we see subgraph NFT
marketplace created in NFT
marketplace. Now, I don't want
it to be in the seller folder.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to move it down a
directory, but you can leave it
where it is, if you want, I'm
going to say move, I'm going to
say move NFT marketplace, star
to dot slash. Now everything
inside of NFT marketplace will
be in this current directory.
And then if the marketplace will
be empty. So with that, I'm
gonna go ahead and delete. And
if the marketplace. Alright,
great. Now let me walk you
through exactly what's going on
here and what these files are
that we just created. So our
first folder is going to be
API's. In order for the graph to
index and read our contract
index our events, it's going to
need the ABI of our events. So
we've got the ABI of our entire
marketplace, from ether scan, if
we didn't verify an ether scan,
we can just create this API
folder ourself and add the NFT
marketplace JSON in here. Now we
have this generated folder. This
is an auto generated file. He
even says at the top, do not
edit this file directly. You can
kind of think of this as the
build folder, or where we
compile graph code. Node
modules, of course, is going to
be node modules and
dependencies. SRC is going to be
where we define and we tell the
graph, how to actually map and
how to actually work with our
contract. And it is a TypeScript
file. So for all of you who have
been just doing this in
JavaScript, I will have to teach
you a little bit of TypeScript
just to get through this part.
Then we have networks dot JSON,
which gives us all of our
network information about which
networks, what are the
addresses, and what are the
different contracts that we're
going to be indexing, package
dot JSON, which of course is
just a normal package dot JSON.
And it's got some graph scripts
already built in schema dot
graph. QL is going to be our
Graph QL schema. So this is also
going to be how we tell the
graph how to actually work with
our events and index our events.
And if you're familiar, the
schema follows the Graph QL
syntax. So if you've ever worked
with Graph QL, before, it's
going to be the exact same way,
graph. QL is a query language
for your API. And instead of
being kind of a relational
database, it can query in a more
graph type way, I'm not going to
go too deep into how it actually
works behind the scenes. But if
you want to learn more, I'm
going to leave some docs in the
GitHub repository associated
with this course, the sub graph
dot Yamo tells our subgraph how
to combine all the files
together. So we have data
sources, data sources, where
they're coming from different
addresses, different entities or
events, the API's where to grab
our files from different event
handlers, which we'll talk about
in a minute. And then the main
file, which is going to be our
mapping.ts, we have a TS config,
which is a configuration file
specific to TypeScript. And then
of course, we have our yarn dot
lock. With all this information
with all this code, we are now
going to update all this code to
tell the graph to start indexing
our events. So we can read our
events from the graph in a
decentralized context, as
opposed to from a centralized
database. And after we build
everything, we're going to run
through this off and deploy
code, which is to authenticate
ourselves, and then deploy our
code to the graph to start
indexing. So without further
ado, let's jump in. And let's do
this. So one of the first things
I'm going to do, I'm going to
add a highlighter for these dot
Graph QL files. So in our
extensions, we're gonna look at
Graph QL. And we're gonna stall
this Graph QL extension. Now
that we've installed it, if we
go back to schema dot graph, QL,
we've got it with some colors
now, which is exciting. So this
schema dot Graph QL is going to
define what entities we have in
our contract if we were to be
analogous to mirallas. These are
going to be how we're going to
define what our tables are going
to look like. And these are
going to be our events. plus
that active item table that we
created. So we're not going to
have an example entity though,
we're going to have a type
active item. And this is going
to be an add entity. So these
are the different types we have
in our graph that we can
actually query on, our main
thing that we're going to want
to query on is same as before,
it's going to be our active
items. And then inside of our
active items, we're going to
tell the graph, what parameters
each one of these active item
types has, well, it's going to
have an ID of type ID. So the
variable is ID of type ID. And
you can read more about the
different types in the graph
documentation. And this
exclamation mark means it must
have an ID. So every active item
needs to have and will have an
ID, we'll say there's going to
be a buyer, which is going to be
an address, so that's going to
be a byte and the buyer could be
blank, right? It could be the
0x 000, we're going to have all
of our active items have a
0000 dot.if. If no one has
bought yet, we're going to have
a seller, which of course is
also going to be a bytes because
it's going to be an address,
we're going to have an NFT
address. So the address of the
NFT, which will also be bytes,
we're going to have a token ID
which isn't going to be bytes,
this is going to be of type big
int, and then we're going to
have a price, which is also
going to be a big int. Now price
we're going to leave as not
required for price, we're just
going to have price be nullable.
So price can be null. So we have
an active item. Awesome. What
else are we going to need? What
what other tables do we have in
Morales? Well, we're going to
need type item listed. And this
is going to be at entity is
going to need an ID, it'll have
a seller. Whenever an item gets
listed, it's going to have a
seller right, which is going to
be a bytes again. And if the
address the address of the NFT,
which will also be bytes, the
token ID, which is going to be a
big int, and then the price,
which will also be a big end,
we're gonna need a type item
cancelled at entity
which will have an ID seller an
NFT address. And a token ID will
be a big end. And then last type
item bought will be in that
entity is going to have an ID
ID. It's going to be a buyer
bytes.
And then of T address a bytes
and a token ID again, and then a
price of beginnt. And with
Justice Information, we've
defined what we want our
subgraph to keep track of wants
to keep track of item bought
events, item, cancelled events,
item listed events. And then
we're going to make this new
active item table similar to
what we did with mirallas. And
it's going to be some function
of these these other three
events. And now we're done with
our schema dot graph. QL.
Awesome. So what do we do now
we're going to need to tell our
sub graph to actually listen for
these events. So what we can do.
So what we want to do to tell it
how to listen for these events,
is we're going to go to src
mapping.ts. It's this mapping.ts
file that's going to tell our
subgraph how to actually map and
how to actually store all the
event information that we have.
If you look in it right now, it
might even give you kind of a
sample event. So it says Export
function, handle item event.
This is what Maya says right
now, it takes as an input
parameter event item bot. So
this is saying whenever an item
bot event occurs, do this handle
item bot function. So anytime
item bot happens do this handle
item bot. And we're actually
getting this item bot from our
generated NFT marketplace from
some generated code. In the
graph. If we run graph code Gen.
This graph code Gen command
grabs all the stuff we have in
the schema dot Graph QL and puts
it in this generated file. Now
that I've run graph code Gen,
you'll see in here there's an
item bot class, you see there's
a schema, that type script. And
actually we can even find that
new active item class that we
created in our schema. So
anytime you update schema dot
Graph QL, you're always going to
want to run graph code Gen, so
you can update those types. And
if this failed, it means that
you messed up something in your
schema dot Graph QL. Now in our
mapping.ts, we're actually
importing item bought item
cancelled item listed from
generated and if the marketplace
and if the marketplace from our
generated code. These are going
to be our events. And we're not
going to need to do anything
with the NFT marketplace. We're
just going to need our event
information. For now. Let's go
ahead and just delete everything
inside our handle item bot or
whatever sample is given to you.
So we're importing a or events
from our generated code. And
then we have this line here,
which we're going to change in a
second. So again, we have these
three functions handle item
bought, handle item canceled and
handle item listed. Whenever we
get an item bought event, we're
going to do this function.
Whenever we get an item canceled
event, we're going to do this
function. And all this code is
defined in our sub graph dot
Yamo. You can see the different
entities here in a bot item
cancelled item listed, and the
event handlers. So it says,
okay, anytime this specific
event gets fired with an index
address, an index address index,
YouTube 36 in YouTube had six
call handle item bought, which
again, we're getting in here
handle item. But so that's
exactly how this works. So let's
figure out what to do when an
item bought event triggers. And
I think that item bought item
cancelled item lists it is a
little confusing. So I like to
change this to item bought as
item bought event item cancelled
as item cancelled event item
listed as item listed event. So
I'm just changing the names of
these three that are imported
from NFT marketplace. And now
I'm going to change event item
bot to item bought event. Event
item cancelled to item cancelled
event and event item listed to
item listed event. Okay, great.
And we're just going to remove
this line for now. And we also
don't need this line at the top
at the beginning, we will in a
minute, but we'll delete it for
now. So here's our minimalistic
code here. So whenever we list
an item, what do we need to do?
Well, we need to save that event
in our in our graph. And then we
also need to update our active
item, exactly as we did with
Morales. So first thing that
we're going to need to do is
either get or create an item
listed object. And something
that we need to know is that
each item needs a unique ID. And
we actually need to create that
ID. So one of the first things
I'm going to do is going to
create a function called Get ID
from event params. And it's
going to take a token ID and
here's where TypeScript comes
into play a little bit. In
TypeScript, we actually need to
define the types of our
different parameters. So token
ID is going to be a big int. And
we'll also take an NFT address,
which will take in a type of
address. And we also need to say
what return type or function is
going to give, which we're going
to return a string, we're going
to create an ID from event
params. And it's just going to
be a combination of the token ID
and the NFT address. The
combination of these two will
give a unique ID for each one of
these types of event. So we're
just gonna say return token ID,
and token ID has a function
called to x string, I'm gonna
say plus, and if T address.to X
string, like so. And big int an
address, we need to import from
at Graph Protocol slash graph
TX. It already imported big
enough for me. So I'm just going
to add address in here is the
two special types that come from
the graph. And then string is
built into TypeScript. Now that
we have a way to get a special
ID for each item in our function
here, we have to now either get
or create a new item listed. Now
right now we have an item. But
event we don't have an item
bought object. So the item
bought object is going to be
what we save, the item bought
event is just the raw event. So
we have to create an item bought
object from our item bought
event. And in TypeScript, these
are going to be two different
types. So we have to import
these item by objects. So those
actually get auto created from
generated schema. In here we
have active item, we have item,
we have an item bought class, we
have an item cancelled, etc. So
we're gonna have to import those
types from there. So we can say,
import, item listed, comma,
active item, item bought an item
cancelled from dot slash,
generated slash schema. Let's go
ahead and get or create an item
bot object. So we'll say let
item bot equals item bot dot
load. And this is how we load an
item we load its unique ID by
calling this get ID from event
params dot load, get ID from
event params. And we can pass
event dot params. That token ID
because an item bot event is
going to have a token ID and
event that params.nf T address.
Now I know we probably should
have done handle item listed
first but we're doing item bot
first. Since we're buying an
item, we probably will also have
an active item as well, right?
We haven't made yet an item
listed. But this is going to be
similar to what we did with
Morales. So we know that every
time we live Certain items will
also list an active item. So
we'll say let active item equals
active item that load. And we're
going to do this exact same
thing. So I'm just going to copy
paste it into here. And even
though these are going to have
the exact same ID, it doesn't
matter because they're the same
ID across different types. Now
we're gonna say, if there is no
item bot, we'll say item bot
equals a new item bot object.
And we'll give it an ID, which
is going to be exactly our ID
giving parameter here, get ID
from events, and pass that
there. So we're going to create
a new item bought here. And now
we're going to update all its
parameters. So back in our
schema dot graph, QL. An item
bought has an ID, buyer address,
token ID and price. So we're
gonna say, item bought, that
buyer equals event dot params
dot buyer, item bought.nf T
address equals event.params.nf T
address, item bot, dot token ID
equals event dot params dot
token ID. And that looks good.
And our active item will be from
item listed, and item listed
should give it all these
parameters, except for it won't
have a buyer. So we just need to
update the buyer on our active
item. So we'll say active item,
dot buyer, we'll do a little
exclamation mark. This is some
TypeScript stuff, saying we will
have an active item. Don't worry
too much about it if you're
unfamiliar with TypeScript. And
we'll say that equals event dot
params dot buyer. And now
similar to Morales, we're gonna
do item bot dot save and active
item with an exclamation mark
again, that save and this is how
we're going to save this item
bought event as an object in our
the Graph Protocol. And also,
we're going to update our active
item. So this is our full
function of handle item bought.
Whenever somebody buys an item,
we update a new item bought
object, and we update our active
item to be a new buyer, we're
not going to delete it from our
active items list, we're just
going to update it with a new
buyer. And we'll just say if it
has a buyer, that means it's
been bought. If it doesn't have
a buyer, that means it's still
on the market. Awesome. So now
that we've done our handle item
bot, let's now do our handle
item listed, which will
hopefully make our handle item
bot a little bit easier to
understand. So for handle item
listed, we're going to do the
same piece here. So we're going
to say let item listed equals
item listed dot load. And we're
gonna do the exact same thing as
what we did for all these will
do get ID from event params.
Like so, get a different event
params. And we're gonna say let
active item. And this line is
going to be exactly the same as
up here. So I'm just going to
copy paste. So we're saying,
okay, great, grab our item
listed, and grab our active
item, see if those objects
already exist. I will say if
there is no item listed, which
there shouldn't be, we'll go
ahead and create a new one,
we'll say item listed
equals new item listed. And its
ID is going to be from this
function that we created are
unique IDs. Now, unlike what we
did above, we're also going to
say, if there is no active item,
then we're going to create a new
active item, right? Because
we're listing an item, it
shouldn't be an active item. Now
this functionality is going to
make a lot more sense here,
right? Because if we're updating
the price of an item, active
item will already exist. If it's
a brand new listing, though,
active item will not exist. So
we'll say okay, if it doesn't
exist, okay, that means it's a
brand new listing, we'll say
item listed equals new item
listed, and then we'll give it
an ID. That's the same ID
methodology, paste that in. So
now all we got to do is update
these new objects. So I will say
item listed that seller equals
event dot params dot seller. And
I'm just going to copy paste
this line. Because this is just
gonna be active item dot seller
now. Oops, see me and then it'll
make this active item. active
item instead of item listed. And
what else comes with item
listed? Well, let's go to the
schema item listed has an NFT
address, token ID and a price.
So okay, so let's add those.
item listed dot NFT address
equals event.params.nf T
address. Copy paste this line
because it's gonna be the be the
exact same for active item. Now
item listed that token ID equals
event dot params dot token ID.
Copy paste this line. Same thing
for active item. Item listed dot
price equals event dot params
dot At price, copy, paste this
line for active item. And then
we just say those two. So item
listed that save active item.
Save. So in our protocol here,
if it's already been, if there
already is an active item, then
we just go ahead and we get that
active item. This would be for a
listing that we're updating. If
not, we make a new one. We
update it with whatever came in
through the event. And then we
save it to our graph protocol.
Okay, perfect. Now we only have
one left, item cancelled. So
let's figure out how to do item
cancelled, it's going to look
really similar to item bought.
So we'll say let item cancelled
equals item cancelled that load.
Again, we're going to do this
exact same Id get our that we're
doing for everything, we'll say
let active item equals, and I'm
going to zoom out a little bit
less active item equals active
item dot load. Or do this exact
same thing here. Boom. And then
we're gonna say, if not item
cancelled, which there shouldn't
be because this should be the
only item canceled event here.
We'll say item cancelled, equals
new item cancelled. And we're
gonna give it an ID using the
same ID methodology we've been
using. Now this is going to look
a little bit different. We're
gonna say item canceled, that
seller equals event dot params
dot seller. So far, so good.
Item canceled dot NFT address
equals event dot params dot NFT
Address item canceled dot token
ID equals event dot params dot
token ID. And then finally, we
are going to change the active
item a little bit different than
what we've seen. active item
exclamation mark again, ignore
if you're confused by that dot
buyer. And we're going to update
the buyer to equal address dot
from string.
We're going to give it what's
called the Dead address. And
that's this right here.
0x 1-234-567-8910 1112 1314
producing 718 1920 21 to two to
three to 45 to 67 to
8930 3130 230-334-3536 zeros
lowercase d, uppercase E,
lowercase A uppercase D, this is
known as the dead address. And
this is how we're going to
decide if an item is still on
the marketplace or not. Or if an
item has been bought or not. If
we have the dead address as its
buyer, that's going to mean that
the item has been cancelled. And
that's how we are going to be
able to tell that an item is on
the marketplace or not dead
address means it's been
cancelled. An empty address,
which is what will happen for
handle item listed means it's on
the market. And an actual real
address means that it's actually
been bought by somebody. So the
way we can tell if it's on the
market is it's 0x 0000000.
Because the data address is
obviously going to be different
than than all zeros. The data
address is a commonly used
address kind of as a burner
address that nobody owns, then
we can just say, item cancelled
that save an active item that
say active item, exclamation
mark dot save and perfect. Our
mapping file is now completed.
We now have three different
functions to define how to
handle when items are bought
events, how to handle when items
are cancelled event and item
listed events. And if you're
confused, remember all the code
for this is available on this
the graph section of my GitHub.
So you can just follow along
with the code here, if you ever
get lost or need help. And with
that, we're almost ready to tell
our subgraph to start listening
to our contracts, there's just
at least one more thing that we
want to do. So in our sub graph
dot Yamo, we'll see source
address blah, blah, blah, this
is telling us to start indexing
events since the beginning of
Aetherium. Now we don't really
want it to do that, because it
will take a really long time, we
want to tell our subgraph Hey,
you don't just start from
beginning of time, you just need
to start from right before our
contract was deployed. So we can
add what's called our start
block to tell it what block
number to start deploying. Now
if we have our address, which we
do right here, we can copy it,
we can paste it on to the rink
fee, ether scan, paste it in
here, or really any block
Explorer, and we'll see what
block number our contract was
deployed. And it looks like it
was this block. So I'm going to
copy that address, go back to my
code and say starting block,
it's going to be right here.
Starting block is going to be
when it was deployed, minus one.
So we're gonna go right before
we deployed our contract, we're
going to start reading any event
that is indexed from it. Now if
you just deployed this, it might
not have any events in it at
all, which we're going to fix in
just a minute so don't worry,
but with that all the
instructions for how to build
Our sub graphs are ready to be
deployed to the graph, start our
indexing and start working with
our instructions in a
decentralized context. So what
we can do now is back in the
graph, we actually have the auth
and deploy code right here, we
can copy this, this graph auth
dash dash studio, which is our
deploy key on how to deploy. And
we can run this in our code
editor. So we're going to paste
that in here, graph off dash
studio, hit enter. And we're
gonna say deploy key set for the
graph. So this is just setting
us up so that whenever we push
our code, it's going to push it
to this sub graph configuration
that we've made on their site to
help us deploy automatically.
Now we can do, we don't need to
enter the subgraph, because
we've already moved stuff down,
is we'll build the sub graph,
we'll run graph code Gen, we can
just run graph kojem,
which again, is just going to
make sure our schema dot Graph
QL looks good. And then we're
going to run our graph build.
And this graph build command is
going to compile and run all of
our sub graph stuff, everything
in mapping that JSON all our
generated code. And it's going
to put this into a real build
folder, the generated folder has
kind of like a pseudo build
folder. And then we have a real
build folder. So the generated
is just to build some typings
for our TypeScript. And it's
this build folder, this real
build folder, is what we're
going to actually be deploying
and sending to the graph. And we
can actually deploy our
subgraph. Now, with graph deploy
dash s studio. And if the
marketplace, which we're going
to run right now, now is going
to give us a version label
option, which we're going to
give it the 0.0 point one, since
this is our first version, and
it goes ahead and starts
deploying it to the graph, we
also get to upload our sub graph
to IPFS. And we have a little
hash right here for IPFS for a
subgraph that we could look at.
But now if you're successful, we
now have this build completed
thing. And we have these sub
graph endpoints for queries and
subscriptions. So we can
actually start querying and
subscribing to our sub graph.
But if we go back to our site
here now and we hit refresh, we
can now see status deployed, we
can see that we're sinking. And
now we have some nodes that are
listening for our events to be
emitted here, which is
incredibly exciting. We can go
to logs to see if anything went
wrong. And right now it's just
indexing, it's listening. It's
going through all the different
blocks in the blockchain,
listening for our events. And
then we have a playground here
where we can run some queries to
see different events and the
different responses from our
Graph QL, which right now, it's
totally blank, because we
haven't done anything yet. So
once again, let's pull up our
hard hat and ft marketplace
code, or open it up in a new
terminal, whatever you want to
do. And let's go ahead, and
let's run our mminton list
script. But for rink B, so we'll
do yarn, hard hat, run scripts,
mint, and list item dash dash
network Rinkeby. So we're going
to mint an NF T, right, this is
going to be to transaction, so
we're gonna have to wait a
little bit, and then we're going
to approve the NFT. And then
we're going to list it on our
marketplace. And once it's
listed, it's going to emit an
item listed event. And we should
see now we have an active item
and an item listed data in our
Graph QL. Now you can learn more
about now what you see here on
the left hand side is what's
known as a Graph QL query. Now,
we're not going to go over how
to do these, but I'm going to
leave some links in the GitHub
repository. If you want to learn
how to do more of these queries,
these are going to be similar to
what we saw with Morales. But
instead of them being kind of
regular table lookups. They're
in Graph QL syntax, and the
results of our query, end up
being over here, we can see more
information about our schema all
the way to the right over here.
But if we look at our code, now,
we've made the NFT approved it
we've listed it on our
marketplace. So now if we go
back to the graph, and we run
this query, and we do a little
refresh on our NFT marketplace,
we might have to wait a few
minutes for the graph to index
these new blocks. But in our
playground, we should see the
show up as a query. If you don't
automatically get these you can
pause the video to write these
into your Graph QL playground,
right? So after a few minutes,
refresh on ether scan, I can see
that list item transaction has
gone through. This means we've
emitted a new event. So if I
come back to my playground, and
I hit play here, oh my goodness,
we can see we have active items.
And we see we have item listed.
This is fantastic. That means in
a decentralized context, we have
a off chain service that is
indexing our events for our
contract so that we can update
our front end and we can update
people in a decentralized way.
This is so exciting.
Awesome, so now that we have
this all set up, we can finally
go back to our next JS project
or next Jas NFT marketplace the
graph FCC. The reason we did all
this is because right Now in our
code base for our next Jas NFT
Marketplace application, we're
reading from a Morales database,
which we're not going to do
anymore. Instead of reading from
a Morales database, we're going
to read from the graph, let's go
ahead and learn how to update
our code our index dot j, s to
read from the graph instead. So
to highlight this, to show this,
we're actually going to create a
new page, a new file, and we're
just going to call it graph,
example, dot j, s. And we're
just gonna make this a really
minimalistic page to show you
how to do a graph query. So
similar to index dot j, s, we're
gonna do export default graph
example. It's going to be a
function, or default function,
graph example. And we're gonna
use this tool called Apollo
client, copy, paste it over. And
we're going to add it with yarn,
add dash dash dev at a P O ll O,
slash, client, or excuse me, not
Dev, because we do need this on
the front end. So yarn add at
Apollo slash client. Oh, sorry,
we also need to do yarn, add
Graph QL, we need to add both of
those. And it's this Apollo
slash client, which is how we're
going to make queries to our
newly created graph. QL. So
we're gonna say import the use
query hook, from this package we
just installed from at a P, O,
ll o slash client. And we'll
also import G QL. So to create a
new query, we'll say const, get
active item equals g QL. And
we'll add this backtick here.
And we'll add all of our Graph
QL stuff in here, this is gonna
be equivalent to this, this is
Graph QL. Syntax. And we're
gonna be putting this Graph QL
syntax into our code base here.
But we only want to get the
active items. So how are we
going to get the active items?
Well, we can actually build it
over here on our playground
first, and then add it to our
code base. So we'll say we want
to grab the active items, we'll
grab the first five, and then
we'll say where the buyer is
going to be 0x 12345678. We're
saying where the buyer is empty.
So we're grabbing the active
items where there is no buyer,
and then we're going to do and
then we're going to get the ID,
the buyer, the seller, the NFT
address, token, ID and the price
from that. And if we hit run, we
get our active item here. So we
see here, the buyer is this
exact 0x 12345678 Because it
gets defaulted to zero when
there is no buyer. And this is
why for item cancelled, we
updated the buyer to be that
dead address. So if it's bought,
it won't be active anymore. And
if it's cancelled, it also won't
be active anymore. Now we can
copy this query and paste it
into our code. And now we have a
Graph QL query that we can use
for our graph example. Now in
our graph example, we'll use
this query with this use query
hook. So in export default
function, graph example, we can
say const. And it comes with a
whole bunch of stuff like
loading error, and then the data
returned equals, use query. And
then we'll just pass it this Get
active item, or get active
items, let's put an S on it, get
active items. And then we can
just return return a little div.
And we'll say hi in the div, and
then we'll just do console dot
log data. And then now we'll go
back to our app.js, where we're
wrapping everything in a Morales
provider, we also need to wrap
everything in an Apollo
provider. And we need to
initialize it kind of similar to
how we initialize connecting to
our morale server, but we're
going to initialize connecting
to our Graph QL. So we're gonna
say import a P O ll o provider,
a P O ll o client, and in mem
ory, cache from at a P O ll o
slash client, like that, and
then we'll have to initialize
this so we can delete the morale
stuff. We'll initialize this
client by saying const client
equals new a P O LL. O client,
and we'll give it the parameters
here. And you can find this all
in the Apollo client
documentation will say there's
going to be a cache to help when
we do refreshes and stuff we'll
say new in
memory cache, and we'll say
comma URI, a que where we're
going to be connecting. And this
is where we're going to add the
API for our sub graph. So if we
go back to details, we can see
temporary query URL and this is
a rate limited temporary query,
because this is just a test net,
and we're going to copy this, go
back to our code. And we're just
going to paste it in here. So
whatever you have for temporary
query URL, and your sub graph
studio, that's where you're
gonna paste in here. Now, this
client tells our Graph QL, where
it should be making those
queries. And we're gonna make it
to here. Now, this starts with
HTTPS. So is this centralized?
Yes, because we are directly
calling the graph website.
However, all the data is still
gonna be stored in this
decentralized graph indexer. And
kind of similar to what we did
with IPFS, we're doing this kind
of as a gateway to make it a lot
easier for us to connect and
read the data from the graph
studio. However, in the future,
as more protocols and more
browsers adopt the graph, and
IPFS, this will become a lot
easier inside of our Morales
provider, but outside of our
notifications provider, we're
gonna say a P O ll o provider,
and then client equals client.
And then we're going to copy the
closing tag, and put it around
the notification provider and
press Save. Now I'm gonna save
our front end, now we're going
to try to run our front end. And
we're gonna have to change some
stuff in here because it's going
to freak out. So we're gonna run
yarn Dev, for new front end. So
we're gonna go to our localhost
3000. And it's going to totally
freak out, because we still have
some morale stuff in here. And
that's totally okay. We, of
course, we don't need a hard hat
Node running. Because we're on a
test net, we don't need to be
synched with Morales, we don't
need to be doing any of that
stuff. Because we're working
with a test net, right now, it's
actually not freaking out, which
is great. But it shows obviously
nothing for recently listed. So
what we're going to do now is
we're gonna do slash, graph
example, and hit enter. And we
can see Hi, show up. But if we
go to inspect, and we go to
console, a console here, we can
see an object here of active
items, which is returned from
the graph with buyer ID, NFT,
address price and all this stuff
in the air. This is fantastic.
So okay, okay. Okay. So all we
have to do now is we just have
to update. So let's go ahead,
we'll kill our server. For now,
all we have to do is update,
instead of use mirallas query,
we're going to delete this. And
we're just going to query from
Apollo query from our Graph QL.
And everything else stays the
same, right? Because our NFT
box, and all the rest of the
code that we worked with, will
still work exactly the same. So
first, we just got to get our
address. So we're gonna say
import, same as Sell, sell NFT,
import the network mapping, so
I'm actually just going to copy
it. So we're going to import
network mapping from constants,
network mapping dot JSON. And
now we can say const.
Marketplace, address equals, and
we're going to get the exact
same way we did this and sell
NFT to, so we're going to grab
this line getting the chain
string, we'll paste that in
here, which means we're going to
need to get chain ID from user
Morales. And then we're gonna
get the marketplace address like
this. So we're going to copy
that line, paste it in here.
Okay, great. Now we have the
marketplace address. So now
we're just going to do const.
Loading error data, which we can
do listed. And if T is again,
equals, use query, and we can do
that get active items. So what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a new file and constants,
we're going to pass that get
active items thing in their new
file, we're just going to call
it sub graph queries, dot j, s.
And then here, we're gonna say
import G QL. From at a Apollo
slash client. And we'll say
const, get active items, equals
g QL backtick. And exactly what
we did in that great, let's go
back to the graph example, we'll
just copy that whole line
actually pasted in here. And now
we'll just do export default,
get active items. And we'll
import this query from sub graph
queries into our index dot j s.
So we'll say import, get active
queries are skimming apt get
active items from dot dot slash
constants slash sub graph
queries. And now in our use
query will pass Get active
items, which should return are
listed NF Ts. So now, we'll
change this from fetching listed
NF Ts to loading, loading, or we
don't have listed NF Ts. So if
it's loading or we don't have
listen if TS then do loading,
otherwise, we're going to do
another mapping, but the return
of the Graph QL is going to be a
little bit different. So instead
of listing MTS dot map, it's
going to be listed NF T's dot AQ
two have items, dot map and f t,
and then we're going to get
price. And if the address token
ID, we're not going to get
marketplace address, but we'll
get seller from NFT. And it's
not going to be returned with
attributes. So we can just do
console dot log NFT instead. And
then we just pass all that stuff
normally to, to that NFT box
exactly the way that we did
before. So really, we're all
we're doing is we're swapping
out the query methodology here,
price is going to be from price
price is going to be from the
query, and ft address is going
to be from the query token ID
from the query marketplace
address, that's also gonna be
slightly different, we're going
to get that from our own config
seller is going to be from the
query, and then the key is going
to be from the query as well. So
now if we save that, if we
restart our website, with yarn
Dev, and we go back to our
homepage, we should see
everything exactly the same,
except for the images being
pulled from the graph, instead
of being pulled from her Alice.
Let's go back to our front end,
we'll give it a nice refresh,
close out the console. And we'll
go to our homepage. And I forgot
to do use query. So let's import
use query, import, use query
from at a Paulo slash client.
Let's save and let's go back and
give that a refresh. And oh, my
goodness, we now have updated to
get our events from a
decentralized data structure.
That's freaking awesome. Now
let's talk about hosting this
real quickly, we are using the
image tag in here in our NFT
box, we are using the image tag
in here from next Jas, which
comes with some pre processing.
So it's a little hard to use on
IPFS. So we would need to update
the way we do images in order to
host this on IPFS. But we still
can do that. Some other options
we have actually are Morales, we
can actually even host our apps
on Morales, if we want. We can
also use things like for cell or
Netlify, or etc, or really any
other traditional centralized
hosting service. Now, if you
want to, I challenge you to
update this code to make it be
able to be hosted on IPFS. So
that you'll have an end to end
decentralized. And if the
marketplace first wanted to make
a PR to this code, so that it
can be successfully hosted
completely end to end on IPFS
wins and empty for me. But wow.
And with that we are done with
less than 15. This is an
absolutely monstrous
accomplishment. And if you
finish this, if you've
understood everything, if you've
gotten through everything so
far, you should feel incredibly
proud of yourself. Because this
is our last full stack section,
our front end section and you're
a full stack monster at this
point. huge congratulations, you
should be super, super, super
proud. And definitely take a
break, go get a coffee, and get
ready for the final stretch of
lessons 1617 and 18. Those are
gonna go by a little bit
quicker. I'm very excited for
you take a break, and I'll see
you there.
Right, welcome to Lesson Six
tene, where we're going to be
going into even more low level
code here. The hard hat upgrades
of course, per usual, our entire
GitHub repository is located
here. And additionally, we have
an optional video that you can
watch. If you want to learn
more, we're actually going to
watch a slice of that video that
explains upgradable smart
contracts. So let's jump in. Now
I'm editing this video much
later after I filmed that, hence
why I have a beard so I'll be
jumping in from time to time
updating some of the sections.
When deploying your smart
contracts on chain. We all know
that those smart contracts are
immutable or unchangeable. But
what if I told you that they
were immutable?
Well, technically, that wouldn't
be correct. However, smart
contracts actually can change
all the time. When people
transfer tokens when people
stake in a contract or really do
any type of functionality. Those
smart contracts have to update
their balances and update their
mappings and update their
variables to reflect this. The
reason that they're immutable is
that the logic itself never
changes and will be on chain
like that forever. So
technically, yes, once they are
deployed, they are immutable.
And this is actually one of the
major benefits of smart
contracts in the first place
that nobody can tamper with or
screw with our smart contracts
once we deploy them. However,
this can be an issue if, for
example, we want to upgrade our
smart contract or protocol to do
more things, or want to fix some
glaring bug or issue that we
have. Now even though we can't
change the specific code that's
been deployed to an address, we
can actually do a lot more than
you think. And in this video,
we're going to explain the
different methodologies behind
upgrading your smart contracts.
And then we're going to show you
how to do it with hard hat and
open Zeppelin huge shout out to
a lot of open Zeppelin and
trilobites articles that helped
me put this video together and a
number of other sources as well
links in the description. So
let's get to it. Now at first
glance, you might be thinking,
if you can upgrade your smart
contracts, then they're not
really immutable that in a way
you'd be right. So when
explaining kind of the different
philosophies and patterns that
we can use here, we do need to
keep Behind the philosophies and
decentralization implications
that each one of these patterns
have, as they do all have
different advantages and
disadvantages. And yes, some of
the disadvantages here are going
to affect the centrality. So we
need to keep that in mind. And
this is why it's so important
that before you go ahead and
jump in and start deploying
upgradable smart contracts, you
understand the trade offs. So
we're going to talk about three
different ways to upgrade your
smart contracts. The first one
being the not really slash
Paramor ties way to upgrade your
smart contracts, the social
migration method, and then the
method that you probably have
heard about, which is proxies,
which have a ton of
subcategories, like metamorphic
contracts, transparent
upgradable, proxies, and
universal upgradable proxies. So
let's talk about the not really
upgrading method, or the
parameterization method, or
whatever you want to call it.
This is the simplest way to
think about upgrading your smart
contracts. And it really isn't
upgrading our smart contracts.
Because we can't really change
the logic of the smart contract,
whatever logic that we've
written, is there, we also can
add new storage or state
variables. So this is really not
really upgrading. But it is
something to think about
upgrades is just parameterizing,
everything, whatever logic that
we've deployed is there, and
that's what we're interacting
with this function means we just
have a whole bunch of setter
functions. And we can update
certain parameters. Like maybe
we have a reward parameter that
gives out a token at 1 percent, every
year or something like that.
Maybe we have a setter function
that says, hey, update that to
2 percent, or update that to 4 percent. It's
just a setter function that
changes some variable. Now, the
advantages here, obviously, this
is really simple to implement.
The disadvantage is that if you
didn't think of some logic or
some functionality, the first
time you deployed their smart
contract, that's too bad, you're
stuck with it, you can't update
the logic or really update
anything with the
parameterization, aka, not
really method. And the other
thing you have to think about is
who the admins are, who has
access to these setter functions
to these updating functions. If
it's a single person, guess
what, you have a centralized
smart contract. Now of course,
you can add a governance
contract to be the admin
contract of your protocol. And
that would be a decentralized
way of doing this. So just keep
that in mind, you can do this
method just need a governance
protocol to do so another
example of this might be a
contract registry. And this is
something actually that early
versions of ABA used before you
call a function, you actually
check some contract registry
that is updated as a parameter
by somebody and you get routed
to the contract, and you do your
call there. Again, this really
doesn't allow us to have the
full functionality of upgrades
here, you can argue that this
registry is a mix of one of the
later versions. But for all
intents and purposes, this
doesn't really give us that
flexibility that we want for
upgrades. But some people might
even think that upgrading your
smart contract is ruining the
decent reality. And one of the
things that makes smart
contracts so potent is that they
are immutable, and that this is
one of the benefits that they
have. So there are some people
who think that you shouldn't add
any customization or any
upgradability, you should deploy
your contract. And then that's
it. trilobites has actually
argued that if you deploy your
contract, knowing that it can't
be changed later, you take a
little bit extra time, making
sure you get everything right.
And there are often less
security vulnerabilities because
you're just setting it
forgetting it and not looking at
it again. Now, if I wanted to
upgrade a smart contract with
this philosophy in mind, the
philosophy that I do want to
keep my smart contracts
immutable, we can instead use
the social migration method,
which I previously called the
Eat method. And now I think it's
less funny. So we're just gonna
stick with social migration, the
social eating method, or the
migration method is just when
you deploy your new contract,
not connected to the old
contract in any way. And by
social convention, you tell
everybody, hey, hey, this new
contract, this new one that we
just deployed? Yeah, this is the
real one now. And it's just by
convention of people migrating
over into using this new one,
that the upgrade is done, hence
my slang name of social yeet.
Because you use the first one
out of the way and move to the
second one.
I think I'm funny. Yeah, this
has the advantage of truly
always saying, Hey, this is our
immutable smart contract. And
this is our new one. This is
really the truest definition of
immutable, because since you
give it no way of being upgraded
in place, than if somebody calls
that contract in 50,000 years in
the future, it will respond
exactly the same. Another huge
disadvantage here is that you
have to have a totally new
contract address. So if you're
an ERC 20 token, for example,
you have to go convince all the
exchanges to list your new
contract address as the actual
address. Keep in mind that when
we do this, we do have to move
the state of the first one over
to the second one. So for
example, if you're an ERC token
moving to a new version of that
ERC token, you do, you have to
have a way to take all those
mappings from the first contract
and move it to the second one.
Obviously, there are ways to do
this, since everything is on
chain. But if you have a million
transfer calls, I don't want to
have to write the script that
updates everyone's balance and
figures out what everyone's
balance is just so I can migrate
to my new version of the
contract. So there's a ton of
social convention work here to
do. trilobites has actually
written a fantastic blog on
upgrading from a v1 to v2 or
etc. With this eat methodology
and they give a lot of steps for
moving your storage and your
state variables over To the new
contract. So link in the
description if you want to read
that. Now let's get to our big
ticket item. So in order to have
a really robust upgrading
mentality or philosophy, we need
to have some type of methodology
or framework that can update our
state, keep our contract address
and allow us to update any type
of logic in our smart contracts
in a easy way, which leads us to
our big ticket item is the
proxies. What's our big ticket
item?
proxies, proxies. Proxies are
the truest form of upgrades,
since a user can keep
interacting with the protocols
through these proxies, and not
even notice that anything
changed or even got updated.
Now, these are also the places
where you can screw up the
easiest. Proxies use a lot of
low level functionality. And the
main one being the delegate call
functionality. Delegate call is
a low level function where the
code in the target contract is
executed in the context of the
calling contract. And message
dot sender and message dot value
also don't change. So you
understand what delegate call
means. Now, right? Great. And in
English, this means if I
delegate call a function in
contract B from contract a, I
will do contracts B's logic in
contract a. So if contract B has
a function that says hey, store
this value in a variable up top,
I'm going to store that variable
in contract a, this is the
powerhouse. And this combined
with the fallback function
allows us to delegate all calls
through a proxy contract address
to some other contract, this
means that I can have one proxy
contract that will have the same
address forever. And I can just
point and route people to the
correct implementation contract
that has the logic, whenever I
want to upgrade, I just deploy a
new implementation contract and
point my proxy to that new
implementation. Now, whenever a
user calls a function on the
proxy contract, I'm going to
delegate call it to the new
contract, I can just call an
admin only function on my proxy
contract, let's call it upgrade
or something and I make all the
contract calls go to this new
contract. When we're talking
about proxies, there are four
pieces of terminology that we
want to keep in mind. First is
the implementation contract. The
implementation contract has all
of our logic and all the pieces
of our protocol. Whenever we
upgrade, we actually launch a
brand new implementation
contract, the proxy contract
proxy points to which
implementation is the correct
one. And routes everyone's calls
to the correct implementation
contract, you can think the
proxy contracts sits on top of
the implementations the user,
the user is going to be making
contract and function calls
through the proxy contract. And
then some type of admin, the
admin is the one who's going to
decide when to upgrade and which
contract to point to. In this
scenario, the other cool thing
about the proxy and delegate
call is that all my storage
variables are going to be stored
in the proxy contract and not in
the implementation contract.
This way, when I upgrade to a
new logic contract, all of my
data will stay on the proxy
contract. So whenever I want to
update my logic, just point to a
new implementation contract, if
I want to add a new storage
variable or a new type of
storage, I just add it in my
logic contract and the proxy
contract will pick it up. Now,
using proxies has a couple of
gotchas. And we're gonna talk
about the gotchas. And then
we're going to talk about the
different proxy contract
methodologies, because yes,
there are many proxy contract
methodologies as well. And this
is why trilobites doesn't really
recommend using upgradable
proxies for your smart
contracts. Because they're
fraught with a lot of these
potential issues. Not to
mention, again, you do still
have some type of admin who's
going to be upgrading your smart
contracts. Now, if this is a
governance protocol, then great,
you're decentralized. But if
this is a single group or
entity, then we have a problem.
The two biggest gotchas are
storage, clashes, and function
selector clashes. Now, what does
this mean? When we use delegate
call, remember, we do the logic
of contract B inside contract a.
So if contract B says we need to
set value to two, we go ahead
and set value to what these
smart contracts are actually
kind of dumb, we actually set
the value of whatever is in the
same storage location on
contract as contract B. So if
our contract looks like this,
and we have two variables and
contract a, we're still going to
set the first storage spot on a
contract a to the new value.
This is really important to know
because this means we can only
append new storage variables and
new implementation contracts.
And we can't reorder or change
old ones. This is called storage
clashing. And in the
implementations we're going to
talk about, they all address
this issue. The next one is
called function select or
clashes. When we tell our
proxies to delegate call to one
of these implementations, it
uses what's called a function
selector to find a function. A
function selector is a four byte
hash of the function name and
the function signature. Don't
worry about the function
signature for now. Now, it's
possible that a function in the
implementation contract has the
same function selector as an
admin function in the proxy
contract, which may cause you to
do accidentally a whole bunch of
weird stuff. For example, in
this sample code in front of you
even though All these functions
are totally different, they
actually have the same function
selector. So yes, we can run
into an issue where some
harmless function like get price
has the same function selector
as upgrade proxy or destroy
proxy or something like that.
This leads to our first of the
three implementations of the
proxy contracts. This is called
the transparent proxy pattern.
And it's actually going to be
the pattern that we're gonna be
demoing to you today. In this
methodology, admins are only
allowed to call admin functions.
And they can't call any
functions in the implementation
contract. And users can only
call functions in the
implementation contract and not
any admin contracts. This way,
you can't ever accidentally have
one of the two swapping, and
having a function selector clash
and you running into a big issue
where you call a function, you
probably shouldn't have, if
you're an admin, you're calling
admin functions. If your user
you're calling implementation
functions. So if you're an
admin, and you build some crazy,
awesome defi protocol, you
better come up with a new wallet
address because you can't
participate. The second type of
proxy we're going to talk about
is the universal upgradeable
proxy, or the
op amps. This version of
upgradable contracts actually
puts all the logic of upgrading
in the implementation itself
this way, the solidity compiler
will actually kick out and say,
Hey, we got two functions in
here that have the same function
selector. This is also
advantageous because we have one
less read that we have to do, we
no longer have to check in the
proxy contract if someone is an
admin or not. This saves on gas,
of course, and the proxy is also
a little bit smaller. Because of
this, the issue is that if you
deploy an implementation
contract, without any
upgradeable functionality,
you're stuck. And it's back to
the Eat method with you. And the
last pattern or methodology that
we're going to talk about is the
diamond pattern, which does a
number of things. But one of the
biggest things that it does, it
actually allows for multiple
implementation contracts. This
addresses a couple of different
issues. For example, if your
contract is so big, and it
doesn't fit into the one
contract maximum size, you can
just have multiple contracts
through this multi
implementation method. It also
allows you to make more granular
upgrades, like you don't have to
always deploy and upgrade your
entire smart contract, you can
just upgrade little pieces of
it. If you've chunked them out.
All the proxies mentioned here
have some type of Aetherium
improvement proposal, and most
of them are in the draft phase.
And at the end of this
explainer, we will do a demo of
showing you how the delegate
call function works. And the end
of the demo is right now. So
let's look at delegate call.
Now, we're going to learn about
how to actually build these
proxies how to build these
upgradable smart contracts. And
to do this, we first need to
learn about this delegate call
function. And it's going to be
really similar to the call
function, which we learned much
earlier. If you haven't seen
that, be sure to go back to our
Harnett. And if T's we have a
sub lesson in there, about EVM,
opcodes, and coding and calling
and we'll give you all the
context for delegate call. Like
I said, in the explainer, it's
very similar to call however,
the way that I think about it is
one contract says Oh, I really
like your function, I'm going to
borrow it myself. And we're
going to be looking at solidity
by example. I'll leave a
description in the GitHub. And
all the code for this will be in
the GitHub associated with this
lesson as well. Now we have two
contracts, we have this contract
B that we're going to be
deploying on remix and it looks
like a real minimalistic real
simple contract. We have a
couple of storage variables
here. And then we have a
function that updates our
values, we have a function
called Set VARs and updates are
you into public num? Now as we
learned before, whenever we have
some type of contract with
storage variables they get
stored in, in this storage data
structure that's index starting
from zero, right now are you
into public num is that index
zero, or sender's at index one,
our values and index two etc.
Now we're going to deploy a
contract a and now this contract
is actually going to use the
delegates call function. Now a
contract a this is going to look
a little bit different, but it's
still going to have this set
bars functions, except it's
going to make a delegate call
function call to our contract B.
Now in our lesson 14 with NF TS
we learned about call API dot
encode with signature API dot
encode etc. So if you're
unfamiliar with function
selectors, if you're unfamiliar
with if you're unfamiliar with
this syntax, be sure to go back
to lesson 14 To understand ABI
dot encode with signature and
contract dot call. The
difference here is we're doing
contract dot delegate call. What
this call does is something very
similar to call. Normally, if we
did contract dot call on this
contract, we would just call
this, we would just be calling
this function set VARs, which
would update contracts B's
storage, but instead we're
saying Hey, call that set VARs
function, and then pass this as
an input parameter, but call it
in our contract, call it on
contract a, we're kind of
borrowing a function for our
contract. And so instead, what
we're going to do, is we're
going to borrow this set bars
and run the set bars function
over here. Now the difference is
instead of num equals num The
variables could be named
different than the variables on
contract a. So instead of num
equals num, our contract is
going to say, hey, whatever that
storage of zero have that equal
to whatever we pass as an input
parameter. And if that's a
little bit confusing, just stay
with me. Let's go ahead and
let's see this in remix. So I'm
going to copy paste this code
into remix here. So we can kind
of test and see what this looks
like. Again, there's a link to
this in the GitHub repo
associated with this course,
feel free to pause the video to
grab this link. It's solidity,
hyphen, by hyphen,
example.org/delegate call, or
you can just grab the code
directly from lesson 16 Hardhead
upgrades. So let's compile this
code. And let me show you what I
mean. So I'm going to compile
it, and we'll go to the Run tab.
And first let's deploy this
contract beam, we'll hit Deploy,
we now have a contract, num,
center and value are all blank,
we'll update the number to
something like 777, we'll hit
Set VARS. Set VARs will change
the storage variable num to 777.
And then we're changing the
sender and the value, sender,
and value is zero. Now let's
deploy contract a. So we'll
scroll back up contract a
deploy, of course, we're on the
JavaScript VM. Now we have this
contract a with num value in
Cinder are also all blank. But
when we call set VARs, it's
going to borrow this set VARs
function from contract B and run
it in contract a, you can almost
think of it as if we're copying,
set VARs and pasting it into our
contract a just for one run, and
then immediately deleting ADM,
that's what this delegate call
function does. So when I call
set VARs, we're going to pass it
this contract address as an
input parameter. So it knows to
call this contract said virus
function. When I pass it the
address, and I pass 987. Since
we're borrowing the function,
we're not going to update this
num. On contract B, we're going
to update the num on contract a.
So when I hit Set VARs, we see
num now has 19. Seven, we see
Senator and we see value still
being zero here, because again,
we're borrowing this function
and running it here. Now the way
that this works, is it actually
doesn't look at the names of our
stored variables, it looks at
the storage slots. So when we
borrow this function using
delegate call, so we could have
this these variables we named
anything instead of num, we
could call this first value.
Senator, we could call something
else. And then value we could
call foo, or whatever you want
here. And when we borrow this
function using delegate call,
instead of grabbing the actual
names of the variables, our
contract will swap out these
variable names with the storage
slot. So it says oh, okay, well,
in contract B, you're accessing
the num variable, which is,
which is at storage slot zero.
So when we borrow set bars and
contract a with Delegate call,
we'll say storage slot
zero is going to equal that
underscore num. Which are this
contract storage slot zero is
first value. So we'll say first
value equals underscore Now,
something else is going to be
stored slot two, so it's gonna
say okay, storage slot two,
we're gonna update storage slot
two to message that sender.
Okay? value here is storage slot
three. So whatever's in storage,
slot three, will update with
message dot value like this. So
that's essentially what's going
on behind the scenes. So let's
go ahead and let's delete those
and redeploy. redeploy them. So
we'll deploy contract be
deployed contract a, right now
in B, once again, if we do 1234,
set VARs, we have 123. And then
contract a. Now even though
these variables have different
names, we could grab contract
B's address, paste it in, do
654, hit Set VARS. And first
value is now six by four. So
delegate call allows us to
borrow functions, and then just
transposes whatever is in here
to the storage location
equivalents. And the other thing
that's interesting is even if
you don't have variables, it'll
still save to storage slots. So
in contract a, if we didn't have
any of those variable names,
storage slot, 01, and two would
still get updated. Now here's
where things can get really
interesting. Let's delete our
contract again. And let's change
the type of our contract A's
first value to from a UNT to a
Boolean. Let's save that. And
now let's deploy contract a. Now
when we call set VARs, on our
contract a, it's still going to
use the Set VARs function of
contract B, which takes a
Yewande and assigns the first
storage slot that number we pass
it, but our first storage slot
is now a Boolean was so what do
you think's going to happen now?
Well, let's try it out. Let's
copy contract B's address, paste
it in here. We'll pass we'll do
tu tu, tu as our input
parameter, we'll hit Set VARS.
Our transaction actually does go
through. And now when we look at
first value, it says true. Hmm,
that's really weird. What if we
change set VARs to zero, and hit
Set VARS. And now, first value
is false. In storage here, when
we add a number with set VARs,
it's going through because it's
just setting the storage slot of
the boolean to a number. And
when solidity reads it, it goes,
Oh, well, first value is a
Boolean. So if it's anything
other than zero, it's going to
be true. So this is how you can
actually get some really weird
results. If your typings are
different, or if your stored
variants are different. What if
we made this an address. So this
is where working with Delegate
call can get really weird and
really tricky, really fast.
All right. Now, with all this
being said, let's turn up the
heat. And let me show you a
small proxy, a minimal proxy
example, that shows how a
contract can be used as a
singular address, but the
underlying code can actually
change. And all the code we're
gonna be working with, once
again, in the hardhat upgrades,
FCC sub lesson, small proxy dot
Sol, and you can go ahead and
copy paste this code if you want
to follow along. So you don't
have to code along with me here.
But you absolutely can if we
want. Now, I will say this is
going to be one of the most, if
not the most advanced section of
the entire course. So feel free
to go ahead and skip over this
sub lesson. If you want to just
move on to learning how to
actually build these proxies,
without really understanding
what's going on behind the
scenes. However, it is still
really powerful if you do
understand what's going on
behind the scenes. So I have
this minimalistic starting
position right here. I have
small proxy is proxy. And I'm
importing this proxy dot sole
thing from up in Zeplin.
openzeppelin has this
minimalistic proxy contract that
we can use to actually start
working with this delegate call.
Now this contract uses a lot of
assembly or what's something
called you'll. And it's an
intermediate language that can
be compiled to bytecode for
different backends. It's a sort
of inline assembly inside
solidity and allows you to write
really, really low level code
close to the opcodes. Now we're
not going to go over you'll but
I'll leave some links to the
you'll documentation if you want
to learn more. Even if you're a
really advanced user, you really
want to try to use as little
EULA as possible. Because since
it is so much lower level, it is
much easier to screw things up.
However, like I said, for this
example, we are going to be
using a little bit of you'll now
in this proxy that we're going
to be doing, we have this
delegate function, which inside
this inline assembly, which is
you'll, it does a whole lot of
really low level stuff. But the
main thing that it does is it
goes ahead and it does this
delegate call functionality. If
we look here, we can see it's
using a fallback function and a
receive function. So whenever it
receives a function that doesn't
recognize it'll call fallback,
and fallback calls our delegate
function. So anytime a proxy
contract receives data for a
function it doesn't recognize it
sends it over to some
implementation to some
implementation contract where it
will call it with Delegate call.
In our minimalistic example
here, we have a function called
Set implementation, which will
change where those delegate
calls are going to be sending.
This can be equivalent to like
upgrading your smart contract.
And then we have implementation
here to read where that
implementation contract is. Now
to work with proxies, we really
don't want to have anything in
storage, because if we do
delegate call, and that delegate
call changes, some storage,
we're going to screw up our
contract storage. The one caveat
though to this, we do still need
to store that implementations
address somewhere, so we can
call it so ERP 1976. It's called
the standard proxy storage slot,
which is an Aetherium
improvement proposal for having
certain storage slots
specifically used for proxies.
And in our minimalistic example
here, we set bytes 32, private
constant implementation slot to
that location in storage. And
we'll say, okay, whatever is
that this storage slot is going
to be the location of the
implementation address. So the
way our proxy is going to work
is any contract that calls this
proxy contract. If it's not this
set implementation function,
it's going to pass it over to
whatever is inside the
implementation slot address.
That's what we're going to build
here. So we have the small proxy
is proxy. And we'll create a
real minimalistic contract. So
we'll say contract employee,
mentation A, and we'll just give
it a U and 256. public value and
then function set value, you add
256 new value, public will say
value equals new value So this
is going to be our
implementation. So now anytime
somebody calls small proxy, or
small proxy contract, it's going
to delegate, call it over to our
implementation, a, and then save
the storage in our small proxy
address. So we're going to call
our small proxy with the data to
use this set value function
selector. So let's make it a
little easier just to figure out
how to get that data by creating
a new helper function, do
function, get data to transact.
And we can get the data using
the API dot encode with
signature that we learned in an
earlier lesson. So function get
data to transact, we'll pass it
a un 256 number to update. So
we'll give this the number we
want to call a new value. We'll
have this be public pure, that's
going to return a bytes.
Memory. And we'll just say
return ABI dot ENCODE. With
signature set value, you went to
56, comma, number to update.
So you'll remember this from our
call anything section. And if
you don't remember how to do
that, remember to refer back to
our NFT section to learn how to
call anything and use ABI dot
encode ABI dot encode with a
signature and call anything with
its raw bytes bring and get the
data to transact. And we know
that when we call implementation
a, from our small proxy, we're
going to update our small
proxies storage. So we'll create
a little function in solidity
just to read our storage in
small proxy. We're gonna say
function, read storage. And this
will just be a public view, will
do returns, returns you into
256, value at storage slot,
zero. And we are going to use a
little bit of assembly here
since we are doing all this low
level stuff. And we're going to
call the s load up code to read
the value at storage slot zero,
we'll say value at storage slot
zero, and we're going to set it
and then in assembly, this is
how we set things, we're going
to set it equal to s load of
storage slot zero, and then it
will return this value here. So
we're reading directly from
storage. Oops, and then we need
a little parenthese here. Sorry.
So now, let's go ahead and
deploy our small proxy. And
let's deploy our implementation
A. Now our small proxy has a
function called Set
implementation. So we're saying,
okay, anytime we call this proxy
contract, we're going to
delegate call the functions over
to here. So we're going to grab
current implementations A's
address, paste it into set
implementation 77. So this is
the data of set value you in
256, with that number to update
encoded in it. So if we call our
small proxy, with this data, our
proxy contract is gonna go, oh,
okay, this is a function. I
don't I don't see that function
here. We're going to call our
fallback, right, which again, is
coming from open Zeplin. And our
Fallback is going to do this
delegate, which is this low
level stuff, but it's basically
just doing a delegate call,
we're gonna call our fallback
function, and then we're gonna
get the function in the
implementation A, we're gonna
borrow this function, and we're
gonna use it on our on
ourselves. So if I copy this,
the implementation has been set
to being this address down here.
So all the logic is going to be
done here. So when I go ahead,
and I grabbed this, and paste it
into call data, and I hit
transact looks like it went
successfully went through. If I
read storage, now, we see that
it is indeed 777, which is
incredibly exciting. Now, this
is incredibly beneficial,
because now let's say we want to
go and update our code, right?
We don't like contract
implementation anymore. So let's
go ahead copy contract
implementation A. And we'll make
a new one called implementation
B. Now, let's say whenever
somebody calls set value, we do
value equals new value, plus
one, or plus two. Let's go
ahead, let's save this. Let's
compile this. And let's deploy
implementation B, we'll grab
implementation B's contract
address, we'll call it onset
implementation in our proxy. And
essentially, we have now
upgraded from implementation a
to implementation B. Now, if we
use this same data here, we're
still going to call set value
was 777. But instead, we're now
delegate calling to
implementation B, instead of
implementation A. So if I call
if I put this data into the low
level call data, and I hit
transact, it looks like it went
through. Now I read storage and
now is 779 since doing value
equals new value plus two so
this is a minimalistic example
of how upgrading actually works.
Now, this is incredibly
beneficial, because we can
always just tell people, Hey,
make all your function calls to
small proxy, and you'll be good
to go. But like I said before,
this also means that the
developers of this protocol can
essentially change the
underlying logic at any time.
This is why it is so important
to be sure to read contracts and
check to see who has the
developer keys. And if a
contract can be updated, if a
contract can be updated, and a
single person can update it,
well guess what, you have a
single centralized point of
failure. And technically the
contract isn't even
decentralized. Now, something
else I was talking about in the
video is function clashes
function selector clashes. Right
now, whenever we call set
implementation, the proxy
function sedimentation gets
called because we don't trigger
the fallback because we can see
the function is here. However,
if I have a function called Set
implementation, in our
implementation, this one can
never be called, whenever we
send a function signature of set
implementation, it's always
going to call the one on the
proxy. This is where the
transparent proxy that we're
going to be working with can
help us out here and the
universal upgradable proxy can
help us to, and I'm not going to
go too much deeper into these
now. But we've left some links
in the GitHub repository to
teach you more about these
selector clashes. And how those
two proxy patterns that I just
mentioned, the transparent and
universal upgradable can get
around these, if you're confused
by anything in here, go into
this discussion thread and make
a new discussion about proxies
make a new discussion about the
Assembly about the you'll set
implementation, this is a great
time to connect with other
people taking the course and ask
questions here, because I know
that this is a really advanced
section, and requires you
haven't gone through a lot of
those sub lessons that we've
gone before. And if it takes you
a couple times of playing around
with solidity and playing around
with remix, I definitely
recommend you do so this is the
section we're seeing really is
believing. And I want you to
jump into remix. And I want you
to test this. And I want you to
play around with this and see
what you can break and fiddle
with. But with all that being
said, we finally have all the
knowledge that we need to build
our hardhat project that deals
with upgrades. So let's go ahead
and jump into it.
Your new terminal, we're going
to do MK dir, hard hat,
upgrades, FCC, CD, hard hat,
upgrades, FCC, and then code
period, or file, open folder,
this folder here, now I'm going
to grab that same yarn add we've
been grabbing from less than
nine, we're gonna paste it in,
we're going to add all of these
different parameters. And once
again, we're going to copy over
our hard hat config from
previous sections, we're going
to copy over prettier. And we're
just going to get our basic
default setup. At this point,
you might have a setup that
works best for you and that you
like better. And feel free to
grab that as well. So I'm going
to paste the prettier is in
here. And I'm going to paste the
hard hat.config.js that we've
been using, instead of running
yarn hard hat. And now we should
be good to go. So let's create a
new folder called contracts. And
in here, we're going to create a
new file called Box dot soul.
And then it's this contract,
that's going to be our
implementation or our logic
contract. So it will say pragma,
solidity carrot zero point 8.7
contract box will say you into
256 internal value will do event
value changed you into 256 new
value, do function store, you
went to 36 value, this will be a
public function will say value
equals new value. So this store
function is going to update our
variable at storage slot zero,
internal, and then we'll just
omit value changed that new
value. And then we'll just
create function retrieve, which
will be a public view returns a
UNT 256 We'll just do return
value. And then we're going to
create a new function called
version. And this will be a
public door. And that returns a
un 256. And we're just going to
have this return one. So our box
contract here is going to be
version one. Now we're going to
copy all this code, paste it
into a box v two dot soul and
rename it to contract box v two,
we're going to update the
version to version two here. And
we're going to create a new
function called increment. And
this will be a public function.
And we'll say value equals value
plus one. And then we will emit
a value changed event with
value. We're going to have one
contract address originally use
the logic in box and then we're
going to upgrade it to the logic
in box V two. And we're going to
learn how to use all the tools
that we've been working with
here to add this logic and
create this logic And let's just
make sure this works, we'll do
yarn, or that compile.
So let's make a readme.md, we'll
say, one, we're going to upgrade
box to box V two. So we're going
to make a proxy contract, that's
gonna point to box. And then
later on, we're going to update
it to point to box V two. Right,
so we're going to start it up
pointing to box, then we're
going to have it point to box V
two. And that's how we're going
to upgrade it, one of the first
things we're going to need to do
is deploy a proxy, we can deploy
a proxy manually ourselves, and
we can build the proxy contracts
and do all that stuff. That's
our first option. Hardhead
deploy also comes built in with
deploying and upgrading proxies
itself, where we can just
specify that we want to use a
proxy. And we could specify the
type of proxy that we want to
use. So number two is just
saying using hard hat deploys,
built in proxies. And then
number three is open Zeppelin
actually has an upgrades plugin,
which allows you to write some
really simple scripts that
allows you to have a really
simple API like upgrades dot
deploy proxy, and then upgrades
that upgrade proxy. Now for this
section, we're going to be doing
the hard hat deploys built in
proxies. However, in the GitHub
repo associated with this, if
you go to scripts, there's other
upgrade examples that will show
you how to use the opens up and
upgrades plugin. And we're not
going to do deploy a proxy
manually manually, because we
essentially just showed you how
to do that in our sub lesson. So
we're going to show you this,
we're going to show you the
Hardhead deploys built in
proxies, and if you want to use
the openzeppelin upgrades
plugin, that is available in the
GitHub repo as well. So let's go
ahead and do this. So we're
going to go ahead and we're
going to make a new folder, or
deploy folder. And first, we're
going to make a new file called
a one, deploy box dot j s. And
this is going to look really
similar to everything we've been
doing so far. So module dot
exports, equals async function,
we're going to get named
accounts and deployments. The
arrow function will say const
deploy COMM A log equals
deployments const deployer
equals await, get named.
Accounts, do a little logging,
like this, and then we'll say
const, box equals await, loi,
box, comma, we'll say from
Deployer, comma, args like this,
we'll say weight con formations
is going to be network dot
config dot block confirmations
for Masons. And yep, we got to
grab const from hard hat. And
then we can add the parameter in
here for proxies. And this is
where we can add a ton of
information. So like I said,
we're going to use the
transparent upgradable proxy
from open Zeppelin, which if we
want to use it, we're going to
have to add open Zeppelin. So
we'll do yarn, add dash dash dev
at open Zeppelin slash
contracts. And we can tell our
hard hat to deploy this box
contract behind a proxy will say
the proxy contract is going to
be the open Zeppelin transparent
proxy. And we're also going to
do a via admin contract. So
instead of having an admin
address, for the proxy contract,
we're going to have the proxy
contract owned by an admin
contract. And doing it this way
is considered a best practice
for a number of reasons. But
we'll name this admin contract,
box proxy admin and the artifact
for this box proxy admin. So
we'll need to create a box proxy
admin contract to be the admin
of our box. So in our contracts
folder, create a new folder
called proxy. And in here, a new
file called Box proxy admin that
saw and this is going to be the
admin contract we're going to
have for controlling the proxy
of our box so inbox proxy admin
dot Saul will do SP DX license.
I then to fire MIT pragma
solidity, carrot zero, point
8.7,
say contract, box proxy admin,
like this, right? And once
again, we're going to use one of
the open Zetland tools in the
transparent folder. They have a
proxy admin dot Saul, which is
going to be essentially what our
box proxy admin is going to be.
It has some functionality, it
has some functions in here like
change, proxy admin, upgrade,
upgrade and call for dealing
with upgrades. All contracts. So
we're going to import it will do
import at open Zeppelin slash
contracts slash proxy slash
transparent, slash proxy admin,
dot soul. And we'll say our
Brock's box proxy admin is proxy
admin, like this. And to have
this box proxy admin work with
the heart at deploy plugin, our
constructor needs to take an
address owner as an input
parameter, but we're just going
to leave that blank. And then,
and then we need to do the proxy
admin, which is just going to be
blank as well. And that's it.
That's all we're going to do box
proxy admin contract, which just
has all of the functionalities
to do upgrades and change proxy
admin and all this stuff. We're
going to deploy our box contract
behind a proxy and opens up and
transparent proxy that is owned
by our Brock's proxy admin
contract in the template
Aetherium contracts. GitHub repo
is actually an examples slash
opens up on proxies branch that
will show you how to work with
different types of proxies. And
there will be a link to this in
the GitHub repo associated with
this course. And then we'll do
our verification, say, chains
dot includes. And we'll go
ahead, I'm going to copy paste
our hard hat helper config from
our last project, which has
development chains, hard hat and
local host that we export, will
import this as well. const
development chains equals
require dot slash helper hard
hat config. If development
chains dot includes network dot
name, and process dot env dot
ether scan API key log,
verifying that the same as we've
done a way to verify last, we're
going to copy over our utils
folder. So just copy, paste, we
now have verify, which will
import it in here. So we'll do
const verify equals require dot
dot slash utils, slash verify,
await verify box dot address.
And then args is going to be
blank. So we'll just do blank
here, and boom. And that's going
to be it for our box deployment.
So we can test this out by
running yarn Hardhead deploy,
see if everything works here.
And that's it done. And then we
should do actually, we should
add log beach true as well.
Let's run this again, much
better. So you can see we
actually deploy a couple of
contracts. So we deploy our box
proxy admin, which is going to
be our admin contract, then we
deploy box implementation. So
hard hat deploy, went ahead and
took our box contract and
renamed it to box implementation
and then deployed it, then it
deployed our box proxy here. So
anytime we call this address, it
actually will point to the logic
of our box. Now what we can do
is we can write a deploy script
to deploy box, the box v2
implementation, and then upgrade
our box to box V to create a new
deploy script called Zero to
deploy box v2 dot j s or deploy
box two dot j s. And we'll do
something really similar here.
Right, so I'm just going to copy
pretty much of this, paste it in
here. Now we're going to do
const box v two equals await,
deploy. Box v two, comma, from
Deployer. Log True RMS blank,
weights confirmations, it's
going to be network dot config
dot lock.
Or masons, then I'm going to
copy the verification code, copy
this, paste it here, server,
this is going to be box v2 dot
address. Okay, great. So we now
have some code where we can
deploy box and box v2. Now let's
go ahead and write a script to
actually upgrade these. So we'll
do a new folder, scripts. New
File, and we'll call it upgrade
box dot j s. Now we're going to
do it the manual way here. And
the reason we're going to do it
the manual way is because I want
to show you exactly the
functions that we're calling to
do this upgrade process.
However, hard hat deploy also
comes with an API to make it
really easy to actually just
upgrade your box contracts. This
is gonna be script. So we'll
start off with async function
main. And then we'll copy paste
our traditional script, main dot
then process exit blah, blah,
blah, that whole thing. We're
first gonna get the box proxy
admin contract. We'll say box
const. Box, proxy admin equals
await ethers dot get contract,
box proxy admin and we got to
import you Here's from Hardhead,
then we're going to get the
actual proxy, which is our
transparent proxy. So we'll say
const transparent proxy equals
await ethers dot get contract,
box underscore proxy. Since hard
hat deploy, we'll just name the
proxy the name of the
implementation underscore proxy.
And then of course, we're going
to need our box V to contract.
So say const. Box v two equals
await ethers dot get contract,
box V two. Now we can say const,
upgrade TX equals a weight box
proxy admin, that upgrade. And
we're going to call the upgrade
function on our box proxy admin,
which calls it on our
transparent proxy, which will
change the implementation from
box one to box two. So box proxy
admin, that upgrade, we're going
to upgrade the transparent proxy
dot address to our box B to that
address, it will look in our box
proxy, a box proxy has an
upgrade function which calls
upgrade to on our transparent
upgradeable proxy will do a
weight upgrade TX dot wait one.
And now to work with the
functions on our box v two,
we're gonna say const proxy box
equals await ethers dot get
contract. At box v two, we're
going to get the box v two ABI
however, we're going to load it
at the transparent proxy
address. This way ethers knows
okay, we're going to call all of
our functions on the transparent
proxy address. But this proxy
box is going to have the ABI of
box v2, which is what we want.
Now we can say const version
equals await proxy box dot
version. And we'll say console
dot log version. And if we want
to compare this to its original
implementation, before we
upgrade, we can do the same
thing. We can say const proxy
box v1, let's actually call this
proxy box V to say cost proxy
box v one is going to be this
exact same thing
equals this call box here. And
we'll do const version equals
weight, right proxy box v1 dot
version, console dot log
version, or version v1, version
v1. We'll call this version v
two, version v two, and proxy
box V two. So we'll get our
version v one will upgrade. And
then we'll see at that same
address what the version
function now returns. So let's
open our terminal. If I run
yarn, our head node will spin up
a node will have deployed our
admin our implementation, our
proxy, and then our box V to
implementation. I'll make a new
terminal. And I'll run yarn,
hard hat run scripts upgrade box
that J S dash dash network,
local host. And we should see
that box actually update. And
that's exactly what we see. And
then let's do well, it's I
forgot to do.to string in here.
But it goes from version one to
version two on that exact same
address. And with that little
code, we have successfully
learned how to upgrade our smart
contracts programmatically. Now,
like I said, in the GitHub repo
associated with this lesson, you
can also check out the upgrades
plugin from open Zeppelin. So to
work with that, you would just
do upgrades dot deploy proxy
proxy to call the Prepare
upgrade function, and then
upgrade upgrade proxy just like
that. They also have an upgrade
tutorial, step by step for
hardhat that you can follow
along with as well. Now I know
this was an advanced section.
And I know we went a little bit
quick here. But honestly, if you
just finish this section, not
only have you completed all
these other sections that make
you a really powerful smart
contract developer. But you've
learned some really advanced
stuff here. We've gone into low
level code like delegate call,
we've gotten to assembly we've
gotten to you'll we've gotten to
these proxy patterns, which can
really make you a an incredible
stand out developer in the smart
contract space. So if you just
finished this section, you
should be so so proud of
yourself because we went really
fast and because there's a lot
of advanced information here.
Now, like I said, 100 percent, be sure
to go into the discussions tab
and ask questions and connect
and talk to other people in the
area. Maybe look at the already
running discussions and jump in
and start asking other students
and start asking other people
about what they've learned and
how their proxies are going. And
if they made anything really
cool. If you're just excited and
you want to go to the show and
tell section, make a show and
tell me like hey, here's my
GitHub repo for doing this
upgrade section. going here and
be excited with that being said
go and take that coffee break go
take that walk go to the gym go
get excited Go tell your friends
we are almost done we have two
lessons left and then you're
home free
All right, welcome back to
lesson 17 For hardhat. Douse,
you're almost done. Now for this
section, I've actually already
made a video on how to code a
dowel with TypeScript and
solidity in JavaScript. So we're
actually just going to play this
video for this section. The
reason we're going to display
this one is because I did a lot
of work to make this one look
really good. And it's still
incredibly up to date. So this
is going to be in TypeScript and
solidity. However, we're going
to have the JavaScript edition
of the code base in this code
from the video section. If you
want the most up to date version
of this delta template code, you
can use, you can select this up
to date code, which goes to this
doubt template repo. I'll be
updating this repo periodically
with new Dao examples and new
ways to create doubts or
decentralized autonomous
organizations. Now, before we
learn how to code a doubt, we
should learn what the DAO is.
And again, I've already made a
video that I've put a lot of
work into. So we're going to
watch what a Dow is from a high
level first, then we're going to
learn how to code a Dow. And
then our last section is going
to be security and auditing. And
we're going to finish this out.
So Bucklin, let's learn what a
Dow is. And then let's go ahead
and build a Dow, let's do it.
Now, daos for decentralized
autonomous organizations is a
bit of an overloaded term. But
it typically describes any group
that is governed by a
transparent set of rules found
on a blockchain or smart
contract. And I say overloaded
because some people say bitcoin
is down because the miners can
choose whether or not to upgrade
their software. Other people
think that Dows must use
transparent smart contracts,
which have the rules ingrained
right into them. And then other
people think Tao is just a
buzzword, so they just slap the
name relay on to any
organization so that they can
get some clout. And this makes
for sad, Patrick. And it's not
to be confused with the Dow,
which was an implementation of a
Dow back in 2016, which set the
record for the largest hack at
that time. So there's a lot of
different ways to think about
and the Dow term is used in a
lot of different ways. But in
essence, imagine if all of the
users of Google were given
voting power into what Google
should do next. And the rules of
the voting was immutable,
transparent, and decentralized.
This solves an age old problem
of trust, centrality and
transparency, and giving the
power to the users of different
protocols and applications
instead of everything happening
behind closed doors. And this
voting piece is a cornerstone of
how these operate this
Decentralized Governance, if you
will, and it can be summarized
by company or organization
operated exclusively through
code. And to really understand
all this, we're going to look
under the hood of the protocol
that's setting the precedent for
all other doubts and compound,
then once we look at compound,
we'll understand what goes into
building one of these and all
the trade offs, all the
different architectural choices
mean for your group. And then in
my next video, I'm gonna have a
full coat along tutorial for
developers looking to build one
of these themselves. But be
absolutely sure to watch the
rest of this video because it's
going to give you all the
architectural fundamentals. So
you can make intelligent
decisions when you get to that
section. And be sure that you
and your Dow friends smash the
like and subscribe button. So we
can keep giving you the best
engineer first content on the
planet when
it comes to smart contracts.
Let's get into it. So here we
have the compound protocol. It's
a borrowing and lending
application that allows users to
borrow and lend their assets.
And everything about this
application is built in smart
contracts. Now, oftentimes,
they're gonna want to do a lot
of new things, maybe they want
to add a new token to allow
borrowing and lending, maybe
they're gonna want to change
some of the API parameters,
maybe they're gonna want to
block certain coins, there's a
lot of different things that
they might want to do. So that's
where we're gonna go ahead to
governance, this is where you
can find a user interface for
list of all the proposals and
all the different ballots that
came to be. So here's a list of
some of the governance proposals
that this protocol has actually
been making to improve. And
let's look at one of these
proposals that's currently
actually in process. So if we
click on the proposal, we
actually see everything about
this proposal, who voted for who
voted against and the proposal
history here. Now, the first
thing to one of these proposals
is somebody has to actually
create the proposal in a
proposed transaction. And we
actually see that proposed
transaction right here. If we
click on this, and we scroll
down, we can actually see the
exact parameters they used to
make this proposal. Let's go
ahead and decode the input data.
And we can see this is exactly
what this proposal looks like.
The way that they're typically
divided is they have a list of
addresses and the list of
functions to call on those
addresses. And then obviously,
the parameters to pass those
addresses. So this proposal is
saying, Hey, I would like to
call Support Market on this
address, set reserve factor on
this address. Here are the
parameters we're going to pass.
They're obviously encoded with
bytes. And then here's the
description string of what this
is doing and why we're actually
doing this. The reason we have
to do this proposal governance
process is that these contracts
likely have access controls
where only the owner of these
contracts can actually call
these Do functions, and the
owner of these two contracts is
likely going to be this
governance style. And values.
Zero just means that we're not
going to send any eath along
with these transactions, once a
proposal has been created, after
a short delay to becomes active,
and this is when people can
actually start voting on them,
this delay between a proposal
and an act of vote can be
changed or modified, depending
on your doubt, then people have
some time to start voting on
them. And if it passes, which
this one overwhelmingly did, it
reaches succeeded, we click on
this transaction again, and we
go to the compound governance
contract. And we scroll down to
contract, right as proxy, we can
actually see the exact function
that the people call to vote,
namely cast by vote, cast, vote
by signature and cast vote with
reason. We'll talk a little bit
about the exact differences
between these in our next video.
But these are the functions that
they're actually calling. And if
you go to the compound app, and
we go over to vote, this is a
user interface you can actually
vote through to make it easier
if you're not as tech savvy. So
you can vote right through this
app dot compound at finance. Or
you can just send the
transaction yourself. Once all
those votes happen. It reaches
this queued stage. Now what is
queued mean? Well, before a
proposal actually becomes
active, there's a minimum delay
between a proposal passing and a
proposal being executed. So
somebody has to call this cute
function. And it only can be
called if a vote passes. And it
says, OK, that postal ID has
been cued, and we're going to
execute it soon. Now, if we go
to a different proposal, like
this one, for example, we can
see it has been executed, we can
see somebody called this
executed function. And they
executed Proposal A detail. So
this is going to be a full
example of the lifecycle of a
proposal going through this
process. Now there are a couple
that even failed, a whole bunch
of people voted against this.
And if you scroll down, you can
see it was created, it was
active, and the majority of
people voted against. So that's
where it stops. Now oftentimes,
just putting one of these
proposals through isn't enough
to really garner some votes for
it, you generally want a forum
or some type of discussion place
to talk about these proposals
and why you liked them or don't
like them. Oftentimes, a
discourse is one of the main
places that people are going to
argue for why something is good,
or why something is bad. So
people can vote on these
changes. And again, snapshot
might be one of these tools that
you use to figure out if your
community even wants something
before it even goes to vote, you
can join one of these, and with
your tokens actually vote on
things without them being
executed just to get the
sentiment or like I said before,
you could build your protocol in
a way that snapshot actually
helps you with the voting
process. All right, now you've
seen the protocol that has been
influencing all the other
details on how to vote. Now, you
know, now that we know what a
doubt looks like,
let's talk about the
architecture and tools that go
into building one of these and
additionally the trade offs that
they have. And the first thing
to talk about here is going to
be the voting mechanism. Now
voting in Decentralized
Governance is critical to these
days, because sometimes they do
need to update and change to
keep up with the times. Not all
protocols need to have a Dow,
but those that do need to have a
doubt need a way for the
participants to engage. This is
one of the most important
questions to ask him to tell
your communities. How do I
participate? How do I engage in
this doubt? How do I help make
decisions and you'll find this
is a bit of a tricky problem to
solve. Now, an easy approach to
this problem is going to be
using an ERC 20 or an NFT token
as voting power. Similar to what
we saw with compound use the
comp token to vote for different
proposals seems simple enough,
right? Boom, problem solved
gray. Now, this actually might
be the right approach for
certain doubts. But it also runs
the risk of actually being less
fair. Because when you tokenize
the voting power, you're
essentially auctioning off this
voting power to whoever's got
the deepest pockets, whoever has
the most money gets to pick the
changes. So if it's only the
rich people who get to vote,
then it's highly likely that all
the changes in the protocol are
going to benefit the rich, which
doesn't really seem like that
great of an improvement over our
current world. And if T's are
interesting, because they have
this non fungible component, but
yet, even they still run into
this issue. Additionally, if you
buy a whole bunch of votes, you
make a bad decision and then
sell all your votes. You as an
individual don't really get
punished, you just punish the
group as a whole. But you being
malicious, you can get away with
pretty scot free now again, this
voting mechanism is going to be
correct for some groups, but for
other groups, maybe not. It
really just depends on what your
down community setup is going to
look like. Now the next one
we're going to talk about is
skin in the game. Now metallic
has actually written a lot about
this and I highly recommend you
read his article, link in the
description to see that the skin
in the game method means that
whenever you make a decision,
your vote is recorded. And if
that decision leads to a bad
outcome, your tokens are axed.
You get punished for making evil
or bad decisions for your Dao
and your protocol. I like this
mentality because even if you
buy a ton of tokens and decide
to be ill with it, you can be
held accountable for your bad
decisions. Now, the hardest part
about this, though, is gonna be
how do we decide as a community?
What is bad outcome? How do we
actually punish these people?
And that's easy, because the
answer is, I'm not sure. Now,
the third method of this voting
mechanism is probably one of the
most interesting ones, but also
the hardest ones to implement.
And this is proof of personhood,
or participation. Imagine that
all users of the compound
protocol were given a single
vote simply because they use the
protocol. And even if they had
1000 wallets, they use the
protocol. One human being means
one vote, this would be amazing,
and a far more fair
implementation where votes
couldn't actually just be
bought. The issue, however,
comes in something known as
civil resistance, how can we be
sure that it's one vote equals
one participant and not one
participant pretending to be
1000s of different people, so
they get more votes. This method
hasn't really been solved yet.
But I'm willing to bet some very
clever engineer will do some
amazing chainlink integration,
because proof of personhood is
basically just off chain data
that can be delivered on chain.
And that's exactly where
channeling shines. Now, as you
can see all of these methods and
even more that you probably
think of aren't that far
fetched. And we actually see
these exact same methods
happening in the real world.
Proof of personhood or proof of
participation might just be the
exact same as kind of the
regular government voting that
we see every day. In the United
States, at least one person gets
to vote for one president, you
can't go around making a whole
bunch of fake people and voting
for president. But in companies
the ERC 20 voting standard kind
of applies, the more shares of a
company you have maybe the more
voting power you have in that
company. So we can draw
parallels between the real world
and how voting and governance is
going to work in our smart
contracts. And in fact, you
should draw parallels and look
for inspiration from the web to
space. Now when it comes to
implementation of the voting, I
put them into two categories on
chain voting and off chain
voting on chain voting is
exactly what we saw with
compound, the smart contract on
chain, your voter, you call some
function called vote with your
meta mask your ledger or
whatever, send a transaction and
vote, you voted Congrats, you
can wear your little sticker now
call that function and you send
a transaction, you send a
transaction, what are the
transactions use that are kind
of annoying and kind of costly?
Oh, that's right gas, I imagine
you have 10,000 people in your
community and it costs $100 To
vote per person, you're now
costing your community $1
million. Anytime you want to
change anything. This is
obviously insane, and not very
sustainable for your community
pro here is that the
architecture is really easy.
Everything's going to be
transparent, everything's going
to be on chain. And that's
really good. But yes, the con is
that you're going to break the
bank account for a lot of people
potentially. Now there are a lot
of variations of this to help
solve some of these problems,
especially the gas problem. One
of the ones that I'm incredibly
excited for is this one called
governor's seat, where they use
some random sampling to do some
quadratic voting to help reduce
costs while increasing civil
resistance. You want to learn
more about that one to be sure
to read about it in the
description. So on chain voting
is the simplest one here. But
let's talk about off chain
voting. To cast the vote off to
decentralized context, relax,
relax, you can vote off chain
and still have the 100%
decentralized, you can actually
sign a transaction and sign a
vote without actually sending to
a blockchain and therefore
without actually spending any
gas. Instead, what you can do is
send that signed transaction to
a decentralized database like
IPFS, count up all the votes in
IPFS. And then when time comes,
deliver the result of that data
through something like an Oracle
like chain link to the
blockchain all in a single
transaction. Alternatively, what
you could do is you could replay
all the same transactions in a
single transaction to save gas,
this can reduce the voting cost
by up to 99%. Right now, this is
an implementation and one of the
most popular ways to do this is
through snapshot. And I'm just
dying for someone to make a
chain link integration because
it's going to be so much safer,
more secure and better and blah,
blah, blah, die for it. This is
your call to action go build
this thing. This option. voting
mechanism obviously saves a ton
of gas to the community and can
be a more efficient way to store
these transactions anyways,
however, it needs to be
implemented very carefully. If
you run your entire Dow through
a centralized Oracle, you are
essentially reintroducing a
centralized intermediary and
ruining the decent quality of
your application. So don't do
that. And if you made it to this
point of the video, give
yourself a little pat on the
back. You're doing fantastic.
Fantastic. Like I said, I have a
video coming out after this one
it's going to show you end to
end how to build one of these
from scratch let's learn about
some of the tools that you can
use to help get you up to speed
quicker. Now there are a number
of no code solutions that can go
into building one of these
dowels Tao stack Aragon. Just
kidding, this is Aragon, colony
and Tao house are all
alternatives that can actually
help you with the upside of
running a Dao and building a
doubt. However, if you want more
granular control and you don't
want to have to pay any the fees
associated with these protocols,
you might want to Do it from
scratch. Now let's talk about
some of the more Cody solutions
that you can use snapshot is one
of the most popular tools out
there for both getting the
sentiment of a Dao. And actually
performing that execution, users
can vote through this protocol
with their actual tokens, those
transaction gets stored in IPFS.
But none of it actually gets
executed. Unless the doubt
chooses to, this can be a great
way to get a feel for what your
Dow wants to do. And Optionally,
you can send the transactions
and execute the votes as well
highly recommend checking out
Zodiac which is a suite of
database tools for you to
implement into your Dallas as
well tally is another one of
these UIs that allows people to
see and actually vote and
interact with these smart
contracts through user
interface. So those of you who
don't know about Gnosis safe,
you absolutely should know Safe
is a multi SIG wallet. And the
reason I put this on the list,
even though it's adds kind of
this centrality component is
that most dowels in the
beginning, are probably going to
start with some type of
centrality, it's much easier to
be fast when you don't have
1000s of people to wait for a
vote. And in the beginning, any
protocol is going to be
centralized to some degree
anyways, using a multisig, we're
voting happens through only a
few key members can be good in
the beginning for your dials,
and often emergencies as well.
But just keep in mind, when you
add one of these, you are adding
this level of centrality, and
then of course opens up and
contracts we love opens up and
contracts. These are the
contracts that we're going to be
basing our Dao code along.
Alright, so that's all the
tools. That's the architecture.
One more thing before I let you
go legality, the future of Dows
is interesting for all these
reasons we just talked about,
but especially on a legal front,
does it make sense for a doubt
to live by the same regulation
as another company? Why would
you even force it down to do
something, you'd have to enforce
them to all vote a certain way
if the government tells you to,
it's a little gray, it's hard to
nail down who to even keep
accountable for these days and
the United States at least you
can actually form your own Dow
and have it legally recognized
in the state of Wyoming. This is
something I want to do. So we'll
just have to see what happens
there. Oh, at this point, you
have been injected with all the
Dow knowledge you need to
succeed and thrive with this new
amazing technology and these new
amazing concepts. And I found
them kill baby. All right, well,
you heard him it's time to
build. Like we said, All the
code is going to be located in
less than 17 Here, let's jump
in.
In this video, we're going to
show you how to build your own
doubt inspired by compound now
this is going to be 100% on
chain voting and on chain
governance. We're going to show
you the easiest way to spin up
an NFT or ERC 20 voting type
down all using solidity and
hardhat. Now if you haven't
watched my last video going over
the architecture of Dows, what
goes into one of these be
absolutely sure to watch that
video first and then come to
this video. Because that video
explains all the philosophy
behind what we're doing here
we're going to be using opens up
and contracts and a hard hat
framework to build this all in
solidity. If you want to see a
brand new or Pythonic version of
doing this, check the link in
the description because we did a
video over at the chainlink
hackathon recently. And
additionally, additionally, we
know that because we're doing
this 100% on chain gas fees are
going to be expensive. So I'm
really looking forward to
somebody doing a chain link plus
IPFS plus snapshot integration
so that we can do all this off
chain. And once that exists, you
already know I'm gonna make a
tutorial on that. And if you
like this style of content, be
sure to smash that like button,
subscribe and leave a comment in
the comment section to let me
know what you want to see. Next,
let me know how you want to
supercharge your smart contract
developer experience. So let's
jump in. Right, so here's what
we're going to be building,
we're gonna have a very basic
smart contract here, right, it's
called box and all it can do is
store a value and then retrieve
a value. But the thing is, its
ownable. And only the owner of
this contract can call the store
function and guess who the owner
is going to be the owner is
going to be the doubt. So only
through a process of governance,
can anyone store a different
function here. And once we're
done, we're going to go through
the entire process of proposing
voting queueing and then
executing a transaction in a Dao
to update our Bach contract. And
that's one of the beautiful
things about these these Dao
setups is that they're
completely modular, right. And
so when I go through the whole
process, I'll do Hardhead tests
here, which my tests right now
are set up to just do
everything, we're going to see
every single step that this Dow
is going to take. So we see box
starting value is going to be
zero. And then all of this stuff
is going to the governance
process. These are just some
some notes. Basically people are
voting, queueing and executing.
And then at the end, we chained
the value of the box contract
through a voting process. And
that's exactly what we're gonna
show you how to do today. Now
remember all the code for what
we're going to be doing here is
in my doubt template GitHub repo
so if you ever get lost, feel
free to refer back to this to
get started. And additionally,
if you want to see the Pythonic
version of this, feel free to go
back to the downmix The main
thing is though that all the
contracts are going to be the
same no matter what brownie hard
hat, dab tools, foundry, it
doesn't matter. So the first
part of this section is gonna be
exactly the same. And here's our
agenda here. First, we're gonna
write the smart contract. So if
you're not familiar with
Hardhead, who cares, we're gonna
be doing the smart contracts
first, then we are going to
write deployment scripts. And
this is where your hard hat
knowledge is going to come into
play. We're going to be writing
our deployment scripts in
TypeScript here, because
TypeScript is phenomenal. If
you're unfamiliar with
TypeScript, I challenge you to
rewrite this in JavaScript and
make a JavaScript version. And
then finally, we're going to
write some scripts to interact
with our governance with our
deployed contracts. Now, a quick
note, this isn't how I
originally built this, I didn't
just read smart contracts, write
deployment scripts, write the
scripts, and then the tests and
boom, I was done, I had a back
and forth between tests, smart
contracts, deploy scripts, etc.
If you're thinking, Oh, my
goodness, that's so easy for him
to go through this. So
seamlessly. When I originally
wrote this code, it was a lot of
back and forth. And that's how
you should be developing, you're
going to be moving between tests
and smart contracts and stuff.
Additionally, in this tutorial,
we are going to show you some
sick Hardhead skills. So you are
not only gonna learn how to
build a Dow, but you're gonna
learn some really advanced
Hardhead skills. So let's jump
in. Let's do this. So the code
editor I'm using is Visual
Studio code. So make sure you
have a code editor up and ready
to go. And you'll need a couple
of prerequisites here. Again,
the prerequisites are in the
GitHub repository, we're going
to need Git, no J, s. And yarn,
if you want to just clone this
repo and follow the instructions
here to get started, you
absolutely 100% can and then you
don't even need to build this
from scratch. But we're going to
want to learn to build this from
scratch. So let's just start git
dash dash version. Great, we
have Git no dash dash version.
Great, we have node, and then
yarn dash dash version. Great,
we have yarn, we can get
started. So everything that
we're going to be installing
here for packages is going to be
a dev dependency. So the first
thing we need to do is do yarn,
add dash dash Dev, hard hat,
if you'd haven't already. And
now in our folder, we're gonna
have node modules package dot
JSON readme and a lock. Of
course, now that we have that we
can run yarn RDAP, we're gonna
get the hard hat CLI up. And
we're going to have all this
stuff in here, we're just going
to create an empty hardhat dot
config dot j s, and we're going
to turn it to TypeScript. The
advanced sample TypeScript
project has a bunch of stuff
that I don't like. So we're just
going to create an empty
hardhead.config.js. And perfect,
we've got a little hard
hat.config.js. Now let's go
ahead and create a folder, or
contracts folder. And this is
where we're going to add all of
our contracts. So the first
thing contract that we're going
to need is the contracts we want
to have govern, which in our
case is going to be box dot
soul. Now, I am actually just
going to copy paste my box, that
soul here, because it's not
particularly interesting. But
you could really code whatever
you want here. So feel free to
pause the video, copy paste from
my GitHub repo, create your own
governance contract that you
want to play with, or do
whatever you want here. But for
us, we just have a store
function, and retrieve function,
and an event, and then a private
value that we're going to be
storing and retrieving. And
that's it. So of course, we want
to fix this. We're importing
from openzeppelin contracts
opens up is amazing. We're gonna
want to add this we'll do yarn,
add dash dash Dev, at opens up
on contracts. And that should
get rid of the box. That's all.
let's reopen box. And boom,
looks like we did a detour to
that perfect. And for
extensions, I'm using the
solidity, the one Blonko, slit
extension. And that's what we
get this wonderful linting
things here. Great. So now we
want to check to see if this
compiles if using remix, you can
compile with remix hard hat,
you're gonna see how we compile
here. Or if you're using you
know, Browning, we just want to
see if this compiles correctly.
So run yarn had a hard hit
Compile. Looks like we ran into
some compilation errors, because
we need to update this, let's
use these 8.8 of solidity we'll
try to compile again. And
perfect looks like we're
compiling successfully. Look
here, we do indeed have our
contract in here. Okay, perfect,
easy part out of the way.
Already. That was so quick. Now
let's start creating the next
part. Let's create the
governance part. So what we're
going to be working with to
build this governance platform
is we're gonna be building it
off of the ERC. 20 standard, so
you're gonna get an ERC 20
token. And that's going to be
the token that you get to vote.
So let's create a new file
called governance token. That's
all governance token dot Sol.
And this is gonna be the code
for the token that we use to
actually vote. Now we're going
to create a normal ERC 20 token.
And then we're going to extend
it to make it governance a bowl
and you'll understand what I
mean in a second. So let's go
ahead and make this spdx license
identifier. It's going to be MIT
pragma solidity we'll do zero
point 8.8. And then we'll do
contract governance token, and
then we'll say is ERC 20 I'm
just gonna go ahead and import
openzeppelin Because open
Zeppelin has a package where
basically has everything we need
for an ERC 20 token. So we're
gonna say import at open
Zeppelin slash contracts slash
token slash ERC 20x We can go to
their github openzeppelin
contracts token, your C 20 And
we'll do ERC 20 Dotto, we'll do
this for now.
token, use your C 20 ditzel.
We're gonna change this, but
don't worry about that yet. Now
we're going to do a un 256
Public Storage Max supply, it's
the best practice, but it's
fine, we'll give this a max
supply this much was going to be
1-234-567-8910 12345678. So it's
gonna be 1 million, we're gonna
do 1 million of these tokens.
And then we're gonna create the
constructor construct or your C
20. Give it governance token as
a name, and then our symbol is
going to be GT. And for those
who who don't know, when you
inherit another contract in your
constructor, you can use that
inherited contracts constructor
as well. In fact, I think you
have to So governance token G
team, and then we'll even call
one of these ERC 20 functions
called mint. And we'll mint to
message dot sender, so whoever
deploys this ERC 20 contract
will just meant them everything,
the whole Max supply. Now
normally, if this was a normal
ERC 20 token, you'd be all done.
But this isn't a normal ERC 20
token. See, when we do votes, we
need to make sure that it's
fair, imagine this for a second,
someone knows a hot proposal is
coming up, they want to vote on.
So they just buy a ton of
tokens. And then they dump it
after the votes over. We want to
avoid this. We want to avoid
people just buying and selling
tokens to get in on governance.
So what we do is we actually
create a snapshot of how many
tokens people have at a certain
block snapshot of tokens people
have at a certain block. And we
want to make sure once a
proposal goes through, we
actually pick a snapshot from
the past that we want to use
this kind of incentivizes people
to not just jump in when it's a
proposal and jump out because
once a proposal hits, it uses a
block snapshot from the past. So
we're actually going to need to
change this a little bit. We're
gonna change this from ERC 20 to
an ERC 20 votes, and we can
actually see this in open
Zeppelin and the extensions
slash ERC 20 votes that soul
contract. If we go back to IRS
to their GitHub, we can see ERC
20 votes, they also have a
snapshot, which is pretty
similar. And some of the main
functions are it has these
checkpoints. So these
checkpoints are basically Hey,
what is the snapshot? There's a
number of checkpoints, you can
also delegate your tokens to
different people. So maybe
you're not going to be available
to actually vote. So you say,
Hey, I'm gonna give my tokens to
somebody else. You can get how
many votes somebody has passed,
votes get passed, or was apply
it has all these functions that
make this token, much better as
a voting tool. Right makes it
much much better. So we're gonna
say our contracts governance
token is ERC 20 votes and we
just have to add additional
constructor, this ERC 20 permit,
I'm sorry, I kind of copied
pasted that. So ERC 20 permit
governance token. And right now
we have a governance token that
is a little bit more capable of
doing actual voting, right,
because as the snapshot has this
delegating functionality, it has
these checkpoints, it's going to
be much better for doing votes
in a fair way. The only thing
that we need to do though, is we
need to add some overrides,
right. And we're just gonna say
the functions below our
overrides required by solidity.
And this part is a little bit
boring. So I'm just going to
copy paste it, feel free to copy
paste it from my GitHub. But
what we're doing is anytime we
do this after token transfer,
and the time we transfer a
token, we want to make sure that
we call the after token transfer
of the ERC 20 votes. And the
reason that we do this is
because we want to make sure
that the snapshots are updated,
right, we want to make sure that
we know how many people have how
many tokens at each block. Same
thing with the mint. Same thing
with burning, we want to make
sure we always know how many
tokens people have at different
blocks or can be at different
checkpoints I should say. And
that's the most important bit at
which checkpoint Are you going
to use for your token voting. So
cool. Feel free to copy that,
again, from a GitHub or if you
want you can even just try the
rest of the tutorial without
this and see how you fare. But
cool. So now we have a
governance token and ERC 20
token that we can use for
governance. So let's try to
compile it. Yarn Hardhead
compile. Great, looks like
things are compiling
successfully. Perfect. So our
governance token looks good. Our
box looks good. Let's actually
now start creating our
governance contracts. Now we're
actually going to make a folder
called governance standard
because this is going to be the
standard governance model. This
is going to be this on chain ERC
20 and I plan on updating this
in the future with no a
governance off chain or
something right. So for now,
we're calling a governance
standard because this is the
quote unquote standard way to do
governance, but in the air,
we're going to need two
contracts actually, we're gonna
need a government work, contract
that soul and then we're also
going to need a time lock that
soul and this will make sense in
a second. So our gov contract
dot soul, this is going to be
the contract that has all the
voting code, all the voting
logic that our governance token
is going to use, the Time Lock
is actually going to be an
additional contract that is
actually the owner. So the Time
Lock and the governor contract
are sort of one in the same, but
the difference is the Time Lock
is actually going to be the
owner of the box contract. And
this is important because
whenever we propose or cue
something to a proposal to go
through, we want to wait, right?
We want to wait for a new vote
to be executed. Now, why do we
want to do that, let's say some
proposal goes through, that's
bad. So like, let's say we have
a box contract. And then a
proposal goes through that says,
Everyone who holds the
governance token has to pay five
tokens, or something like that,
right, or whatever, or who
knows, right? Maybe that's
something that you don't really
want to be a part of. So all of
these governance contracts give
time to give time to users to
get out, if they don't like a
governance update. So we always
want to have some type of
timeline. So once a proposal
passes, it won't go in effect
right away, it'll have to wait
some duration, and then go in
effect. So that's what the
timeline is gonna be for.
Governor contract is going to
have all of our actual code. Now
we can cheat a little bit.
Actually, we can cheat a lot of
a little bit. So opens up one
has a thing called the contracts
wizard, and there'll be a link
to this in the description as
well. And this opens up when
wizard is a way for us to write
really basic boilerplate code
right in there wizard. So right,
so if we go to the wizard
contract here, we can see we can
make an ERC 20 and NFT 1155. And
then finally, this gov thing
here. So we can call it give it
a name, we're going to call Rs.
Gov contract, during explain
what all this means, and give it
a voting delay, which is the
delay since a proposal is
created until voting starts. So
once you create a proposal, you
gotta wait a little bit, the
voting period, how long votes
should go for. And the reason
that this audio is important is
because they actually do votes,
voting period in terms of
blocks. So it's an anti pattern
to actually do timed based
things in smart contracts, it's
much better to do block based
things. So we're saying one
week, but it's that's going to
be you know, if if the average
block time is 13.2 seconds,
we're gonna figure out the weak
proposal threshold is going to
be the minimum number of votes
and account must have to create
a proposal. So maybe you only
want people who have a lot of
your governance token to make
votes quorum percentage, it's
what percentage of people need
to vote it all. So we're saying
4% of all token holders need to
vote or we could say you know,
exactly 100 tokens need to vote
whatever we want to do here. We
also have some updatable
settings we have Bravo
compatible Bravo is the compound
type contract. So if you want to
make it integratable, with
compound you can do that. Votes
comp like or ERC 20 votes, we're
working with this ERC 20 votes,
we always want to do a time
lock, we're gonna do the open
Zeplin implementation of a time
lock, you could also do a
compound implementation, we
aren't going to do upgradability
here, however, I have a number
of fantastic resources on how to
actually do upgradability. And
if we did want to do
upgradability, it adds all this
other stuff. We're not going to
do that for now because it makes
it so much longer video, and
then you can add some stuff like
this, but Oh, so that's pretty
much it. And I know this feels
like you're cheating, or we're
just going to copy this whole
thing, right? Copy all that
stuff that we put in copy to
clipboard, and we're going to
paste it in. Don't worry, I'm
gonna explain what's going on
now. So we have our government
contract. And this is governor
Governor setting Governor
counting simple Governor votes,
Governor votes, quorum Franco,
all this stuff. All these are
just implementations to make it
easier to be governor, Governor
counting simple is a way of
counting votes, Governor votes
is a way of integrating with
that year's 20 contract. Quorum
fraction is is a way to
understand quorum time lock.
Obviously, it's time lock. This
is going to be the base
contract. That's gonna be some
settings. And we're gonna talk
about this in a minute. But
let's go over what are the
functions here so we have voting
delay. This is exactly the
voting delay, which we're gonna
do superdad voting gelei, we're
gonna get from this governor
settings contract that we're
going to set in a minute your
voting period that we're going
to set in our gov settings,
which is this one right here.
And again, if you want to like
look at all these contracts, you
absolutely can, right, if we go
to contracts, governance,
extensions, we have all these in
here, right? So if we look at
governance settings, we can see
it has voting delay voting
period, proposal threshold, and
those are right in its
constructor. And that's exactly
what we're setting, right. We're
setting voting delay voting
period, and then the proposal
threshold, and then we're also
going to make this customizable
as well. And the rest of these
that's exactly what doing
calling the quorum from the
super get votes. And then again,
the super is those inherited
contracts, get the state and
then we have some interesting
functions we have proposed. This
is what we're actually going to
do to propose new governance we
have proposal threshold, and
then we have execute which
executes a cued proposal. To
cancel, we have executor which
we're is going to be who can
actually execute stuff, we're
actually going to make it
anybody and then supports
interface, you can basically
ignore. But let's make this a
little bit more customizable. So
we have Iboats token, this is
going to be our governance
token, the timeline controller
timeline, this is going to be
the timeline controller that we
make an amended. And again, we
need this because we don't want
to let any proposal just go
through once it passes, we want
to give people time to get out.
But let's add the UN 256 voting
delay as a parameter here. And
for voting delay, we're going to
do this, we're going to set it
as our governor settings, we're
going to do a UNT 256 voting
period. And we're going to add
that right here. And this means
45,000 blocks is approximately
one week. And that's what that
means we're going to leave
proposal threshold to zero
because we don't really want to
change that we want to let
anyone make a proposal. And then
we're just going to add you in
256 underscore core
percentage to this. So Governor
votes quorum percentage
corporate senators. So now this
is completely customizable, for
voting, delay voting period,
core percentage for whatever you
want it to be. And believe it or
not, that's it. Now you have a
simple governance contract.
Thank you, openzeppelin, for
doing 99% of the work for us. So
that's it. So this contract,
it's going to have all these
functions that we're going to go
over for proposing for executing
and for queuing, different
proposals. Right. Now we got to
make a time lock contract here.
And this contract is actually
going to be a lot easier. So
we're just going to do it from
scratch. So we're going to spdx
license I then to fire, my team,
do pragma solidity and let's
just do this your point a point
zero, and then we're going to
import from open Zeppelin, a
contract called the Time Lock
controller. So if we look at the
governance here, if this time
lock controller dot soul
contract, and this has all this
functionality in here for
creating roles, who can actually
propose who can execute, who's
the Time Lock admin, but it also
has these execute stuff in here
as well. It's gonna work in
tandem with our governance
contract, right? This is the
contract that says that makes
sure our governance contract
doesn't just push stuff through
willy nilly. So we're gonna say
we're gonna first import that
import at open Zeppelin slash
contracts slash governance slash
Time Lock controller. That's all
and then we're gonna say
contract, I'm lock is Time Lock
controller like that. And we'll
create our little constructor
here, and truck door. And this
because this takes a couple
different parameters, we're
gonna take a un 256 Min delay,
which are min delay, Min delay
is going to be along you have to
wait before executing. So this
is Hey, once proposal passes,
great, we gotta wait this
minimum delay, then we're going
to do a list of proposers, an
address array memory of
proposers. And then the
proposers is the list of
addresses that can propose for
us, we're just gonna say
everyone's gonna be able to
propose. And then last, an
address array, memory of
executors who can execute
everything, and we're just gonna
say executors who can execute
when a probe posle passes. And
again, we're just gonna say
everybody, and the reason we
need these is because we need to
pass these to our time lock
controller, this constructor is
expecting three parameters. So
we'll just do Tama controller,
delay, pro posers, X EQ, tours.
And that's it. So this is going
to be what owns everything, it's
the timelog, that's going to be
owning our box. It's not the
government contract, the
government contracts is where
we're going to send our votes
and stuff. But at the time lock
that actually everything needs
to flow through in order for
governance to actually happen,
because we want to make sure we
have this min delay, we go
through the right process and
everything. And believe it or
not, that's everything. That is
all the code you're going to
need as far as the solidity
goes, to create a governance to
create a Dao. So even do your
own hard hat compile, make sure
everything's compiled. And tada,
we've done it, you've done most
of the hard work. Now we're
going to flip over to actually
writing the scripts to deploy
and to interact with everything
using TypeScript here. At this
point, if you're like, Oh, I
already learned everything that
I wanted, I don't use hard hat,
I use some other tools. This is
where I challenge you to go out
and I challenge you to try
something else. Now if you've
reached this point, I just want
to give you a huge congrats,
because you have taken the steps
to build your own doubt build
your own governance model.
That's all the solidity that you
really need. You can take that
deploy that and you're good to
go. But of course, we know that
there's more to being a smart
contract developer than just the
solidity you got to do the
tooling right to let's go ahead
and we'll jump into writing
those TypeScript scripts to
actually do this. And again, if
you want to see a Python version
of this, go check out a link up
description to see the Pythonic
version of this. And of course,
don't forget to smash that like
button, subscribe, leave a
comment on how you're doing so
far. And, of course, give
yourself a pat in the back.
Great job. You're doing amazing
getting this far. Congrats,
let's jump in.
Alright, so we're back here,
we've written our smart
contracts already, check wasn't
that easy, right, this was way
easier than I thought it would
be. Now we're just gonna write
our deployment scripts, and then
we're gonna write our scripts to
interact with them. Again, my
full repo also has tests, but
we're just gonna write some
scripts. And then feel free to
check out the tests yourself. So
let's write those deployment
scripts to we're actually going
to be using a package for
deployment called Hard Hat
deploy. It is absolutely
phenomenal for hard hat for
making your deployments much,
much easier. We're gonna scroll
down to installation, and we're
actually gonna go ahead and
install this. So typically, you
could install it like this.
Well, we're gonna use yarn, but
we're gonna do kind of the more
safe way which looks a little
wonky, but I'm explaining it
right. So instead of NPM
install, we're gonna do yarn,
add dash dash Dev, and then this
whole thing right here. So we're
gonna do yarn, add dash dash
Dev, and then just paste that in
here. So this is gonna be at
nomic, labs slash hard hat,
hyphen ethers at NPM, colon,
hard hat, deploy ethers. And
what this is doing is we're
basically saying hard hat deploy
ethers is going to be overriding
this hardened ether thing. And
we're also going to add ethers
as well. And then once we add
this in, check our package json,
we can see we have hard hats. We
have hard hat ethers, which is
being overwritten by this hard
hat, deploy ethers. And then
additionally, we're going to
want to add on a deploy. So do
yarn, add dash dash Dev, hard
hat hyphen, deploy. And what
this is going to allow us to do
is instead of having to write
scripts, and do all this stuff,
that kind of makes it hard to
save your deployments and
everything, we're going to just
create a deploy folder, where
we're going to add all of our
deploy scripts in here. So I
absolutely love this package.
It's makes deployment really,
really easy. So in here, we're
gonna create new file, it's
going to do oh one, we're gonna
go step by step deploying
everything, we're gonna call
this deploy, govern or token dot
TypeScript, that's gonna be the
first thing we're going to do.
Also, we're gonna change this to
TypeScript. Tada, we now have
TypeScript. Yay. Now the one
thing that is kind of nice about
doing kind of that advanced
TypeScript thing at the heart
had kind of gives it the
beginning, is you don't have to
install all the TypeScript stuff
yourself. But we do. So we're
going to do yarn, add TypeScript
type chain, vs node at type
chain slash ethers, V five, this
is a lot of stuff, don't worry
type chain slash hard hat, at
type slash Chai, at type slash
node. And then we'll make sure
this is all Dev, dash dash Dev,
I know there's a lot of stuff.
There's all this stuff to make
it TypeScript D.
You can absolutely do this in
JavaScript if you want. You just
have to do JS files and ignore
the typing. So But feel free to
do whatever you want to do.
Alright, cool. And we should be
okay here. Let's go into our
governor token here. And we'll
create a deploy script. So the
Hardhead deploy GitHub repo has
a little demo boilerplate code
for you actually do your deploy
script. So feel free to
reference here if you lost or
confused. So what we're going to
do is we're going to import the
hard hat runtime environments,
from our enhanced slash types.
And you'll see why we need this
in just a second. And then we're
also going to import deploy
function from Hardhead. Deploy
slash types. And these are the
two main things you need to
create a deploy function with
pothead deploy, we're going to
create our function, we're going
to call it const ploy governance
token, it's going to be of type
deploy function. So in order for
these to actually work, we just
create a whole bunch of deploy
functions that we run with heart
hub. And this is going to be an
async function. That's going to
take the hard hat runtime
environment as an input
parameter that we're going to
call HRV. So when we run hard
hat deploy, which you'll see in
a second, we're actually passing
our fake hard hat chain that
gets spun up in the background
for us, right, we can even do
like console dot log Hello. And
if we do yarn, hard hat deploy.
Actually, before we even do
that, if we do yarn, hard hat
dash dash help, you'll see,
since we imported hard hat
deploy up excuse me, we need to
add this to our config. First in
our config, we're gonna need to
do top imports, hard hat deploy
top Roscoe need to import at
nomic labs slash hard hat
ethers, we're also going to need
to import at type chain slash
hard hat. And then we'll leave
it there for now. We'll have to
import more stuff in a second
but literally like that. Now, if
we do yarn hard hat that should
help we should see a new task in
here. And we do we actually see
a ton of new tasks right? Filled
with tasks, check clean compile,
console deployed. And this is
the new task that we have that
actually deploys all of our
contracts, anything that's in
this deploy folder, our head
will go ahead and run right now
in our deploy folder. All we
have is this console dot log
Hello. So if we run yarn, or hit
Deploy, we should See, it just
prints out hello. It'll spin up
a new blockchain background,
while all of our projects and
everything, do some type type
chain stuff, and it says you'll
see this a lot deploy script dot
func is not a function. And
that's because we actually need
to export this now. So we'll do
export default, deploy
governance token. That's why
it's getting mad at us. Now
we'll run yarn had her hard hat
deploy. And boom, we say hello.
So this is how we can actually
deploy all of our scripts. And
we can run everything that's in
this deploy folder in one go,
which is really helpful. So
let's go ahead and deploy our
governance token first. And this
will get a lot faster as we go
along. Don't worry, so delete
this. And first we're gonna do
it, we're gonna say const. We
need an account to deploy this
first. So we'll say const, get
named accounts, deployments, and
network equals HRA. And this is
going to be a little bit more
advanced. This is hard stuff.
This is this is the slick stuff
we're doing here, we're getting
these from our hard hat runtime
environment, which is being
updated from hard hat deploy. So
get named accounts is way for us
to actually import accounts from
our hard hat config, right into
our deploy script. So we're
gonna go to our hard hat config.
And we're gonna create a new
config that's a little bit nicer
than this. So first, we need to
import the hard hat config type.
Since we're using type scripts,
we're going to import hard hat
user config from hard hat slash
config. And we're going to
create a config. So I'm just
gonna comment this out. For now
we're gonna say const. Config,
it's gonna be type hard hat user
config. Equals, and this is
where we can add a whole bunch
of stuff. So let's say our
default network is going to be
hard hat, which is kind of our
local fake blockchain. And then
we're gonna say solidity is
zero, point 8.8, then we're
going to do this thing called
named accounts, which is what we
came here in the first place
for. So this is just a list of
accounts that we can use. So for
accounts, we'll say Deployer,
this will be the name of our
account that does all the
deploying, and we'll just say,
default, is going to be zero. So
whenever we run an any chain,
our zero with account is going
to be named Deployer. What other
thing that we need to do is we
need to add our networks here.
And there's actually two
networks that we're going to
have, we're gonna have a hard
hat with a chain ID of 313337.
And we're also going to have
local hosts of chain ID 31337.
Now, these look like they're
pretty much the same. And I
understand that, but they're
not. And you'll understand why
in a second, but we need them
for now. Just to tell Hardhead
hey, here are the development
fake blockchains that we're
working with? Okay. So this is
kind of our basic setup here.
Okay. I know that was kind of a
lot. But now that we have get
named accounts, we have network,
right? Because anytime you
deploy something, it's going to
be on a network. And when we
deploy something, if you run
yarn, hard hat node, what hard
hat is going to do, it's going
to spin up a fake blockchain in
the background. Oh, it's gonna
be mad at me for a second. Oh,
I forgot to add export, default
config, right, we need to export
the config. Hell hard hat that
we're using this version of
sling. Now if you're on a hard
hat node, you'll see why we
added these two networks up here
hard hat on localhost, we
actually get spun up our own
fake blockchain, we get
accounts, we get private keys,
we get everything right. This is
a hard hat Node running in this
terminal, right? When you run
hard hat node, oddly enough,
it's actually the local host
network. It's not the Hard Hat
Network. When using hard hat
deploy, it's gonna be the local
host network. Or excuse me, when
you use hard hat node, it's
actually going to be the local
host network, not the Hard Hat
Network. The Hard Hat Network is
what it uses when it runs tests.
localhost is when you run this
hard hat node and have this kind
of fake blockchain running in
your terminal. So that's what
the localhost is. Cool. Well,
Ctrl C will kill that. Alright,
great. So now stuff is actually
working. So get them to count
deployments is going to be a
whole bunch of stuff from
deployments, you'll see in a
second and network is the
network that we're on. Okay,
great. So now we're gonna grab
const deploy log equals
deployments, this deployments
object comes with this deploy
function. And this log function,
this log function is kind of
nice for doing logging. And then
we're gonna grab const, employer
equals await, get named
accounts. So we're grabbing from
our config, this deployer
account, right? And it's always
going to be the zero with index.
So it's defaulted to the zero
index for whatever accounts that
were with. Great. So we now have
an account to deploy stuff from
we have a deploy function, we
have all this stuff, we're
looking pretty good. Cool. So
sometimes they'll do like a log,
flying governance token, dot,
and we'll say const governance
token equals await, deploy, and
then the name of the contract
which is governance token,
comma, and these are all the
parameters that we're going to
pass to it. So we're gonna say
from deployer doesn't take any
arguments. So args is just going
to be blank. We're going to do
log to be true so we'll get some
logs printed out for us. And
then I have this wait
confirmations attribute set in
GitHub repo. For now we're going
to ignore this. But if you
follow along with my repo and
you want to auto verify stuff,
this is something that you're
going to want to use. So you
need to wait some amount of
blocks for this contract to be
deployed before you can actually
go ahead and verify it, right.
Because if you're using ether
scan or something, you're gonna
need to wait like, yeah, you're
gonna need to wait a few
minutes. So check out my GitHub
repo for this wait confirmation
stuff, I'm just going to ignore
it for now. Additionally, in my
GitHub repo, I have this verify
function, where we check to see
if it's on a development chain.
And if it is, we don't verify
it. But if it's on like ether
scan or something, we go ahead
and verify it. So be sure to
check the GitHub repo to learn
how to just auto verify without
having to do anything. Now if we
just do this part. And then we
can even do Floyd, governance
token to address governance
token dot address. And we'll do
yarn hardhat. Deploy. Boom. So
we spin up on a fake Hard Hat
Network, we do deploy governance
token to address boom. And this
is how we deploy a fake has
deployed this to our own little
network here. Great. So this
tokens been deployed, we have
our deploy script. Yeah, zoom
out a little bit. Let's zoom out
a little bit. Great. That's the
whole thing. Now we're going to
add one more thing here, we're
going to add something called
delegate function. Now, when you
actually deploy this contract,
nobody has voting power yet. The
reason is, because nobody has
the token delegated to them, we
want to delegate this token to
our Deployer. Right, so we're
going to call this delegate
function. So we're going to
create a new function called
const. delegate. And it's going
to be an async function. It's
going to take a governance token
address as a string, it's going
to take a delegated account,
also as a string, so we're
racing and say, who do we want?
Delegate? Who do we want to be
able to vote with our token?
Okay, so we have created this
async function called delegate.
And how do we do this? Well, we
say Kant's over its token equals
token equals await ethers dot
get contract at.
And probably for two ethers for
us from hardheaded Otto did
that, which is great. That's
what we want. Once it's like
ethers. Thank you vs. Code away.
Ether is like a contract at. And
we're going to say we want our
governance token, which is at
contract, governance token
address. And I have auto format
unsaved, which is why it keeps
formatting like that. This
should be delegated account.
Okay, cool. We have our
governance token contract. Now
we can do const TX or
transaction equals await,
governance token dot delegate
delegate this delegated account
here. And then we can do a wait,
we'll wait for this transaction
to be confirmed by one block.
And then we'll just do console
dot log checkpoints, wait,
governance token dot num
checkpoints delegated account?
So what is this doing? So we
have this num checkpoints
function which we can go check
to see on that ERC 20 token what
this is actually doing. But
basically what this whole thing
is doing, we have this delegate
function that we haven't used
it. But when somebody calls us,
we're saying, Hey, you can use
my vote, take my votes and vote
however you want. And that's
what these this delegate does.
Now, if we look at this token,
here, see 20 extensions, your
see 20 votes, we look at number
checkpoints, we can see how many
checkpoints that account
actually has reason this is so
important is because once again,
like I was saying when people do
a vote, they do it based off
some checkpoints. And anytime
you transfer a token, or
delegate a token, basically call
this function move voting power,
which happens with the back end,
which writes the checkpoint and
says, Hey, at checkpoint x,
here's what everybody has for
voting powers. And that's what
these are so important. And I
know I said before, it's every
block, but it's actually just
every checkpoint, whenever these
checkpoints are updated, that's
gonna be a lot cheaper on gas
than if we just did every single
block, right? That'd be kind of
insane. So the checkpoint for
this governance checkpoint, and
we'll see what that actually is
in just a second. So we'll even
do a wait, delegate, governance
token dot address, and Deployer.
And we'll say log delegated.
Now, when we're on this
function, John Howard hit
Deploy. We have one checkpoint,
which makes sense, right?
Because this was just deployed,
it was just delegated. This
address has one checkpoint.
That's it. And the reason I
checked for this is because if
you see zero checkpoints here,
it means you haven't delegated
correctly. So be sure to check
for checkpoints. But that's it.
We have our deployed governance
token contract done. Bravo.
Let's move on to the next one.
So what do we want to do after
we deploy our governance token?
Well, let's deploy that timelock
or timelock.ts. And we're going
to copy a lot of this stuff over
from here, so I'm actually going
to Oh, and then sometimes you'll
get some weird linting errors
here. I just do det TS ignore
there. And sometimes you'll get
it here too. Oh, actually, we
don't even need network. Okay,
cool. Yeah, you don't even need
network loops. Sometimes we get
some weird linting errors.
Sometimes Vyas code has a hard
time telling understanding like
this, this overwrite thing that
we did. So just run that TS
ignore if if it gives you some,
some engineers, anyways, yes, we
have this Oh, to deploy time
lock here, we're going to deploy
our time lock contract. And
we're going to borrow a lot of
the things that we did from
here, so I'm just going to come
back here are actually going to
copy paste these two top bits.
Again, we're gonna do const
deploy timelock is going to be a
deploy function, it's going to
be an async function that takes
the heart at runtime environment
as a parameter, and cool, nearly
exactly the same sorry. And then
we're going to grab these first
three lines, or first four
lines, I guess, pesos, then
we're going to be getting those
exact same things here. And
we're going to be doing nearly
the exact same thing. So we'll
do log deploying. Time Lock,
point time lock, will do const.
Mark equals await, deploy,
unlock. We'll add some
parameters in here, we'll say
from Deployer. Now does this
take some arguments? It
absolutely does. Right, we can
take a look at the Time Lock,
Min delay proposers and
executors. So what do we want
our min delay to be? Well, this
is a value that we're actually
going to use a lot. So what I
usually like to do is I create a
new file called helper. hardhats
config.ts. And right at the top,
I'll say Export const min.
Delay, and I'll have this delay
be whatever I want it to be. So
let's just go ahead and do 3600,
which is going to be
approximately an hour, right,
you gotta wait this many
seconds, I think that's an hour.
Without the old calculator.
There's 60 seconds, in 60
minutes. Great. That's gonna be
one hour. So wait 30 minutes.
And we're gonna go ahead and
import that here. We'll say
import, Min delay. Wow,
autocomplete for being great.
From helper from, you know, it's
down directory, helper Hardhead
config. And that's gonna be our
first argument here. Our second
argument is going to be a list
of proposals. Now we're going to
leave it blank for now. And also
the list of executors we're also
going to leave it blank for now,
we're going to update this in a
minute. And you'll see why once
we get there, we'll do log true.
This also has a wait
confirmations thing in my
GitHub, but we're going to skip
that for now. It also has an
auto verify, we're also gonna
skip that for now. Then we just
need to export default, deploy
timelock. And boom, we should be
good. So let's try to run this
on hard hat deploying. So now
this should run both of these
great deployed governance token
deployed timelock.
Perfect, we are cruising now
what we want to deploy that
governance contract now. So
let's go ahead and do that.
We're gonna do Oh, three LOI.
Gov, nor contract.ts. And you
guessed it, this is going to
look pretty similar to what we
just did. Right. So in our
deployed time lock, let's go
ahead and just grab those top
two things. We'll paste it in
here. We'll do const deploy,
govern or contract, there's
going to be an apply function,
it's going to be an async
function, taking a part at
runtime environment, save and
close this for now. And we can
even go back and grab these
three lines from our Oh, to
deploy time lock, paste that
right in here, because we're
going to need to get the exact
same things. And additionally,
for this, we're going to need to
get the governance token and the
Time Lock contract. So we'll do
const governance, token equals
await. Get which actually, we
have this, this get function
that comes from these
deployments, which literally
just goes out and gets these
deployments. So we'll say get
Gover Nance token. And then we
also need to get the Time Lock.
So await, get m lock. And we
need these to pass as parameters
for our governor contract.
Right? Because if we open up the
governor contract that soul, we
look at the constructor, it
takes the token, the Time Lock
voting, delay voting period and
quorum percentage as input
parameters. So we'll do a quick
log deploying go burn nor ello.
And they will do const govern
nor contract equals await,
deploy, and will deploy the
govern nor contract I'm not sure
if I'm spelling this right
always, but that's fine. And
we'll do the parameters once
again. So it's gonna be from
Deployer. args are going to be
this list of args. What's the
first thing that it needs? It
needs the token first and the
Time Lock. So we'll do
governance token dot address,
then it's going to need the Time
Lock that address. And it's
going to need a vote on voting
delay voting period and quorum
percentage. So these are also
values that we're going to make
a lot. So let's open back up
that helper Hardhead config, and
let's create those as well. So
we'll say Export const just
voting period. And we'll say
this is going to be five blocks,
we'll do export const voting
delay, this is going to be just
one block, which I know is
really quick. And then we're
gonna need export const Orem
percentage, which we're gonna
say is four 4% of voters always
need to be voting. Excuse me, 4%
of voters need to have voted for
a vote to pass. Great. So we're
going to do voting delay voting
percentage quorum percentage. So
we'll import those so to import
voting delay voting period, or
quorum percentage from helper
Hardhead config. And now that we
have those delay period
percentage, we can just do kind
of a voting delay, voting
period, farm percentage, and
then we'll say log is true.
Again, this one as well. It has
a wait confirmations and auto
verification that we're going to
totally ignore. And then we'll
export default, blood Governor
contract. Oh, Carrie, we're
getting spicy. Let's just make
sure this works. Yarn hardhat
deploy. We should see three
contracts deployed here. I think
to compile governance, token
deployed timelock deployed
governance contract deployed.
Let's go. Alright. Now, we're
not done yet. We have two more
deploy scripts to do. The first
one, we're going to call setup
governance contracts. Okay. And
this one's really important. The
right now our time lock contract
has no proposers and no
executors. Right. So we want to
change that we want to only
allow for the proposer to be the
governor, the governor contract
should be the only one that
proposes things the Time Lock,
and then anybody should be able
to execute the way that this
works. We say the governance
contract proposes something to
the Time Lock once it's in the
Time Lock, and it waits that
period. Anybody can go ahead and
execute it. So Governor contract
everybody votes and everything.
Once a vote passes, Governor
says hey, Time Lock, can you
please propose this? Tom like
goes yeah, sure. But we got to
wait, this minimum delay, once
it's been in delay happens,
anybody can execute it. Now this
would be really cool to do an
integration with chain link
keepers, by the way, for the
chain link keepers to
automatically execute. And I
should build the next anyways.
So we have to set this up so
that these work as such, so
we're gonna create a new deploy
thing called Oh, four, setup,
governance contracts dot
TypeScript. And this is going to
be the code that does all the
setting up. And this is gonna
look really similar once again,
to all of our other deploy
functions. So we'll go head back
from oh three, we'll paste these
two top ones in here, of course,
we're gonna do const setup
contracts, is it going to be a
deploy function, going to be an
async function, it's going to
take HRV art at runtime
environment as parameters, and
then that's the winner right
there. Cool. And we're gonna be
grabbing those same three from
the top, as you can see, that
gets a little bit easier,
because it's kind of repetitive,
right, we're gonna grab that bit
right here. And now we're gonna
get those contracts so that we
can interact with them. And this
is another reason why a hard hat
deploy is so nice, because we
can just do const timelock
equals await ethers that get in
the next let's go ahead and
import ethers from hard hat
imports. Ethers
from Red Hat will even drop a
little TS ignore here. Ethers
dot get contract, we want that
time lock contract. And we say
we want to attach it to the
Deployer. So whenever we call a
function on it, it'll be the
deployer calling that function
and we want to do const Governor
equals await ethers dot get
contract, Governor contract,
this is all going to be attached
to the Deployer. Right. Now,
we're gonna do log setting up
roles. And we're going to set up
the roles right, again, we're
setting it up so that only the
governor can send things to this
time lock, because the Time Lock
is going to be you can almost
think of the Time Lock as like
the president. Right. So
everything goes to the Senate,
the House representative, which
is the governor and then the
President just says yeah, sure.
We just got to wait this minimum
delay, but the President will be
the one to actually execute
everything which I'm not
actually sure that's how it
really works in in politics, but
for for now, that's that's where
we're protecting the president
or the time like is the only one
that can actually do anything
here. So the way that this works
is we're actually going to get
the byte codes of different
roles, right? So if you look at
these time locks here, so we'll
do ones up on contracts. And we
go to the governance here. We go
to Tama controller has these
things called proposal roll,
executor roll time, like admin,
etc. And these are just hashes
of these strings here. But these
are these are bytes 32 saying,
Hey, anybody who has this this
byte 32 is a proposer, anybody
who has this byte 32 is an
executor. Anybody has this byte
there and soon as time like
admin, etc. Right now, our
Deployer account is the time
like admin, and that's bad. We
don't want that we don't want
anyone to be a time like admin,
right? We don't want anyone to
have power over this time lock.
We don't want any centralized
force here. So what we're going
to do is we're going to const
we're going to get those roles.
proposer, proposer role, it's
going to be a weight, unlock
that row pole sir role. And if
you're familiar with multi call,
this would be a great time to do
multi call and copy paste that
whole line x EQ tour role at x
EQ tour roll, we're gonna copy
this whole line admin role. And
this is going to be on lock
admin role. So these are these
three roles that we need to fix,
right, and let's go ahead and
fix them. So the first thing
we're gonna need to do is we're
gonna need to do const row poser
dx equals await Time Lock dot
grant roll, propose a roll to
our governor dot address. So
saying, okay, Governor, you're
the only one who can actually do
anything once you tell the Time
Lock to do something. We'll wait
for the Time Lock period to be
over. And then we'll be done.
And then we'll just do an await
posit TX dot wait one block just
to make sure. Now we're gonna do
the const executor, TX equals
await Time Lock dot grant roll
executor role to nobody, we're
going to execute this we're
gonna give this to nobody, we're
going to say address zero which
is going to be something that
we're going to want to add if we
go to our helper or head config
will say Export const address
zero equals zero by you can just
copy paste this if you want.
There's a couple other ways you
can do this with ethers as well.
We're just gonna do like this. I
like having my conflict this and
then we just import it say
import at zero from dot dot
slash helper Harnett config. So
we're giving the executor role
to nobody, which means
everybody. So once a proposers
thing has gone through, anybody
can execute it. So we'll say
executor, TX That wait one wait
a block. And then got one more
to do here, we need to revoke
role right now our Deployer
count owns that time lock
controller, right. And that's
how we can actually do these
transactions, we can actually
grant role because our Deployer
account owns it now that we've
given everybody access. And
given all the decentralized
access we need, we want to
revoke that role. So const
revoke TX equals await. I'm
locked up revoke role, admin
role from Deployer will do Rotex
that wait, now guess what
anything that's um, like, wants
to do has to go through
governance, and nobody owns the
time I controller, it's
currently after this runs, it's
impossible for anyone to do
anything with the Time Lock
without governance happening.
And then of course, when the
export default set of contracts,
great. And then the last step
that we need to do here is we
need to deploy the contract that
we actually want to govern over
write that box contract, that
real basic contract. So we're
gonna create a new 105, deploy
box.ts. And we're gonna do some
of the same exact stuff we've
done right, so we're gonna grab
these two, these two here, paste
it in, os deploy box is going to
be a deploy function equals
async function, Ah, sorry, hard
hat runtime environment,
we're gonna grab those first
three lines, the TS ignore, just
like that. And now we're going
to deploy this box. So log,
deploying bucks, and we're going
to do const box equals await,
deploy box, give us some values
from our Deployer. args does
this have any args so open a box
dot soul, I don't see a
constructor. And while this is
the easiest contract out of all
these though, no constructor,
and then we'll just say log,
it's going to be true. And
again, if you want to check out
my GitHub repo for that
confirmations, but feel free to
do so it's coming here. And
right now, our deployer has
actually deployed this right,
not our time lock. So we want to
give the boxes ownership over to
our governance process. So now
we're going to do say const
timelock, is going to be a
weight ethers dot get contract.
The same thing as before.
timelock. We're going to grab
ethers from hardhat import
ethers from hard hat. And we're
gonna do a little TLS ignore,
it's being finicky. And then
we're going to transfer the
ownership of our box to this
time lock, okay, and now so this
is actually what's known as a
box deployment. So before we do
that, we have to get the box
contract. So this is a box
deployment object, which doesn't
have contract functions we want
to get the box contract object
so we to box or const box
contract equals await ethers dot
get contract at box and then
we'll just do you know box that
address. You could also do get
contract. Actually both of these
pretty much if you have the
address, you can just do box
that address. You could also do
get contract here. Either one
works now that we have the box
contract, we do const transfer
owner, dx equals await by
contract dot transfer TX or
schema dot transfer ownership to
our timelock dot address, time
walk dot address, then we just
do a weight transfer ownership
TX dot weight one, do a log, you
done it. Those are export
default. Deploy box. Oh, let's
see if this works. So we just
did everything. We're deploying
the GOV token, deploying the
timelock, which owns the
governance process, we're
deployed the governance process,
we're setting up the governance
process so that it's totally
decentralized. And then we
deployed and set up our box so
that it only can be updated
through a governance process.
Let's see if it works. Yarn,
hard hat deploy. Let's see if it
works. Bada boom, you've done
it. So you've just set up a
script to set this entire
governance process up so you can
build your own doubt. Are you
still here? Well, hell yeah, you
are, congratulations on getting
this far, we have one more piece
to go, we just got to write
those scripts. So we can
actually interact with this, we
can actually do a governance, we
can actually see exactly what
the governance process looks
like. Now again, if you didn't
watch my last video on Dows, be
sure to watch that, because
that's going to give you all the
context for this part here. And
if you're still watching 100%,
smash the like button, hit the
subscribe, leave a comment in
the comment section below, it
really helps the channel out. So
proud of you for getting this
far. We're almost there, you're
getting now one more to go. And
then you are home free on
building your doubt. Let's get
back into it.
Alright, so now we're going to
make some scripts to actually
interact with propose Q and vote
on anything that happens in our
Dao. And these are the scripts,
these are kind of the things
that you would do on your front
end when you build this when you
build your doubt on the front
end. Or you could do an
integration with snapshot or
tally or something like that.
And again, if you want to see
come to full functionality on
the GitHub, I have this test
flow.ts It's not the greatest
test here. But you can also
check this out, because it also
does a soup to nuts
demonstration of going through
this exact process. So let's go
ahead and start making some
scripts. So we're gonna create a
new folder called scripts. And
this is where we're going to put
all of our scripts. Now the
process for this is going to be
we're first going to propose
something right? You know, maybe
we're going to propose that our
box contract stores the value
77, right? Because when it first
gets initialized, it's going to
start with zero. So maybe we'll
we'll propose it could start at
77. Once proposing is done, we
are voting on it. Right once
proposals it and we're going to
vote on whether or not we want
the proposal to go through right
yes or no. And then if it
passes, we go to queue and
execute, we queue first. And
then we execute, I'm just
putting them both in the same
script to make it easier. So
let's start with propose here,
because it's going to be the
first thing that we're going to
do. So let's create a new
function. We'll call it async
function, and then we'll
actually export it to export
async function propose. And
we're going to be in here for a
little bit. So let's clear
everything out. And okay, cool.
So this is where we're actually
going to propose on our governor
contract, right? So we're going
to propose a new governor
contract. So the first thing
we're gonna need, of course, is
gonna be the governor. So you
can't govern nor equals await
ethers dot get contract, govern
or contract, right? Since we're
doing ethers, we're gonna have
to do import ethers from heart
app. And then we're still
getting that fundamental thing.
We'll do a little AT Ts ignore
here. Cool. So we have the
governor contract here, we're
going to need the box contract,
we're gonna say hey, we want to
propose the box contract changes
the store value. So we'll do
const box equals await ethers
dot get this is a gift contract,
we want get contract, get
contracts at box. And those are
the two main ones that we're
going to need just to start.
Now, if we look at the proposed
function, right, if we go to
governance, we go to Governor,
and we look at that proposed.
This is what it looks like. Now,
I explained this proposed
function in my last video. So if
you haven't seen it, be sure to
go back and watch it right
because it'll give you
everything that you need to know
here are basically we pick a
list of targets, which our list
is just going to be just our box
contract. These are the targets
that we want to call functions
on, we do values like how much
needed ether we want to send,
which we're not going to send
anything, we have bytes, a array
called data. So this is going to
be our encoded parameters for
the function that we want to
call and then a description. So
that's exactly what we're going
to do here. So first, we need to
figure out what we're going to
do. So look at Box, we're going
to call this store function with
this new value here. So we need
to encode we need to encode this
socks here. And we also need to
encode what we want to upgrade
it to right so we have to code
all the function parameters. So
we'll do const encoded function
call equals box and the way we
can get this box that interface
that encode function data and
This is what actually turns it
to being this bytes call data,
right? So we're encoding
everything and this encoded
function, you can find this in
the ethers documentation, we
have to pass it the function to
call, and then the arguments we
want to pass, right, and this is
how we actually get that. So
let's get these arguments here.
So we're gonna say args, we're
going to make our proposed
function a little bit modular.
So we're gonna say args is going
to be an array of anything, and
then we're gonna say function to
call is just going to be a
string, right, and then right at
the bottom, we're actually gonna
call this, this proposed
function. So we're gonna say
propose, and let's say we want
to give it 77, the function is
going to be what it's going to
be store, store. And that's a
string. And this needs to be a
list. So we're going to do like
this. Now, we're actually going
to use this all over the place.
So since we're gonna be using
this all over the place, we want
to stick them in this part head
helper config. So what we're
going to do is we're gonna say,
export const, new store value
equals 77. And we're gonna do
export const funk equals store.
And I propose, we're just going
to import those. So we'll do
import, new store value, and
also funk from helper Hardhead
dot config, and it added it in
for us, which is great. So we'll
just put new store value in
here. And then we'll put funk in
here. And I know this might look
a little confusing, but
basically, the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna call
this proposed function which
calls you know, post function up
here. Now we're going to do some
fun little then process that
exit zero. And then we're going
to do a dot catch error, which
if there's an error, basically,
we'll just do console dot log
error, then process that makes
it. And this is pretty typical
setup for a really any script
you work with, and hardhat. So
great. So we have constant coded
function call, which has this
function to call an arc. So
we're basically combining these
into this bytes thing. And we
can even print this out, you can
see what this looks like. So you
do console dot log, you see that
this is like this, this crazy
bytes thing here. And the way we
can kind of test this, we'll do
yarn hardhat node, which will
spin up again, our fake
blockchain. But additionally,
with Hardhead deploy, it will
deploy all of our contracts
here, right, we can see timelog
governance, you know, everything
that we need for testing locally
has already been done. So once
we have that up, we can then do
yarn hardhat, run scripts,
propose that TS dash dash
network, local host, this is
important to do, again, because
when you're working with a node
that's running locally, you're
going to be working with local
host, we'll see what it prints
out here.
Contract named Governor
contracts, Governor contract.
Let's try that again. And cool,
you can see this is what that
encoded function call and
arguments looks like is this
really long byte string. But if
you were to decode this, using
the box interface, you would get
the function call and the
arguments, which is really
exciting. So cool, we've encoded
it to bytes. And now what we
want to do, we encourage the
bytes, and now we're going to
create that proposal
transaction. So we'll do console
dot log will say pro posing, and
say, function to call on box
that address with args. And then
we also need to pass a proposal
description. So we're gonna say
pro pose, all description, we
would do it on new line, why
not? Pro pulls all this option,
which we don't have yet.
Alright, we're gonna get it. So
we also need to pass a proposal
description, right, because we
have down here, description. So
let's add another parameter to
our propose here. So we'll say
proposal description, and this
will be also a string. Down at
the bottom, we're going to need
a proposal description as well.
So we'll create a proposal or
export const proposal
description, there's just going
to be some string. So we'll say
proposal number one, door 77 In
the box, that's the description
here, comma proposal
description. And then we import
this or a helper config. Okay,
perfect. So now we have the new
store value, the function the
proposal description, and we can
now call that propose that we
were just looking at so here's
what we're going to do const
propose TX equals await. gov dot
propose. And we need to pass
those lists. So first is going
to be a list of targets, which
for us is just a box that
address right only one target.
And again, these these little
brackets, make it a list of
values, which is just going to
be zero, a list of encoded
function calls or our bytes
data, basically, and then the
proposal description, and then
we're going to do propose, TX
dot wait one. Now, if you
remember, from compound, this is
going to be the exact same if we
go back to compound back to
governance, this transaction is
literally going to be the same
as this created thing here.
Right? And if we scroll down,
like more, we can see the code
input data, those exact same
things on a compound proposal,
right? We have targets values
signatures, well okay, this CES
is a little bit more, this a
little bit more advanced here,
using signatures, but it's got
the same thing called data and
then a description here, okay.
Now since we have a voting
delay, people actually can't
vote until the voting delay
passes. Now, with a local
blockchain, nobody's actually
processing blocks and time
doesn't really pass as quick as
we want. And so we're just going
to speed things up for our own
testing purposes. So the way I
normally do this is I create
this this variable, all
development, exports, on
development chains, and I'll add
hard hat and local host. Because
we can actually do things with
our own local blockchain, we can
actually speed up time, we can
speed up blocks, we can do all
this crazy stuff. So usually,
I'll actually import this in
here. And then we'll do a quick
F. And I'll say, if we're on a
development chain, let's just go
ahead and speed things up for
us. Right. So I'll say if
development chains that includes
network dot name, and then we
can import network from from
ethers, as well. And this is
what I was talking about those
super six skills that you're
gonna learn. If it includes
network dot name, then we're
gonna go ahead and move the
blocks forward, right, because
if we're not on development
chain, we can't actually move
blocks. So what we'll do here is
actually I'll create a new
folder called utilities, you
folder, you are utils. And in
here, I'll create a script
called Move blocks.ts. And we're
just going to create this little
function called move blocks,
which moves blocks for us. And
you'll see how we do this. So
we're going to import network
from heart app, because we want
to speed up that voting delay,
we'll do export async function,
we'll call it move blocks. And
it'll take an amount, which will
be a number, so how many blocks
that we actually want to move.
And then we'll just do console
dot log moving blocks. And we'll
say for let index equals zero,
index is less than amount. index
plus plus, or we're going to do
is we're going to do a weight
network DAP provider dot request
request. And we're going to
request method EVM. Mine. So
basically, we're mining for our
local blockchain, right, so you
can find these docks in the hard
hat docks in the ethers docks,
there's a couple different
places you can find these. But
this is kind of this really cool
hack that we can use to actually
move blocks forward on our local
chain. Now, obviously, this
won't work on an actual chain,
because you'd actually have to
do the mining but on our local
chains, we can absolutely do
this. So we've exported this
move blocks function, and we're
actually gonna grab that Mark
propose, we're going to import
move box from utils blocks. And
we're going to say down here, if
we're on this development chain,
and do a weight move blocks, and
then we'll move blocks by that
voting delay that we were
talking about, right? Because we
need to wait that voting delay
in order to move and it looks
like an auto import it for us
from our helper hardware config.
I told you, we were gonna use
that a couple of times, but
we're gonna move blocks by that
voting delay. Now, this proposed
transaction does some stuff that
we actually want, right? So one
of the big things that it wants
is, is it has this proposal ID.
And if we scroll down to the
event that it emits, it ends up
emitting this proposal ID, we
actually need the proposal ID
for later on when we actually go
to vote. So what we're going to
do is we're actually going to do
const propose receipt equals
proposed text dot weight. And
we're going to get those events
from this proposed receipt. So
we're gonna say const. Proposal,
id equals proposed receipt, that
events, the zero with event
because that first event is the
only one we care about that are
your stop proposal ID. This is
how we get this proposal ID from
this omit also created event. A
couple other ways to get
proposals to get events in
hardhat. And I got a video on it
on my YouTube, if you want to go
check that out. Something else
that we want to do is maybe we
want to see what the deadline is
with a snapshot, you can go
ahead and check my GitHub to
kind of see what the snapshot
looks like or the deadline,
basically, how long we have to
vote, you know what snapshot
you're working with, and all
these different things. But for
now, we're just gonna stick with
the proposal Id be sure to check
out the GitHub for more stuff.
Now we want to save this
proposal ID, we want to save it
somewhere so that our other
scripts so that our vote and our
queue and execute know what this
proposal ID is going to be when
we run those. So what we're
going to do is we're going to
create this file called
proposals dot JSON. And it's
going to store all of our
proposals. So we're gonna say
pro poll, souls dot JSON, it's
going to have all of our
proposals in here. So what we're
going to do and we're going to
add this to our helper Hardhead
config, and do export const,
proposals, file equals proposals
dot JSON. And we're going to
import this at the top as well
as proposals file. And then once
we get this proposal ID, we're
going to do is we're going to
read all the current proposals.
So we're gonna say let proposals
equals JSON dot parse, and we're
gonna do Fs dot read file sync
from this probe proposals file,
and we're going to pass it to
UTF eight. Now, this Fs we don't
have yet, so we're going to need
to import Fs. So we're going to
do yarn add Fs like that. If
we're looking at package dot
JSON. Oops, I should have saved
that as Dev, but I didn't Oh,
well, doesn't really matter. Now
that we have that we can
actually import this into our
TypeScript. So we're just going
to say, import star as Fs from
Fs. And now we can actually use
Fs F as a way to kind of read
from files. Now we can get this
list of proposals. So we got two
proposals that JSON right now
we're just making a blank JSON.
So the first time we run it,
it'll just be blank. But later
on, it'll have stuff in it. And
the way that we're going to save
these proposals is we're going
to say pro proposals of network
dot config dot chain ID, and
this little bank to say, yes,
there will be a chain id.to
string, we're going to store
them by their chain IDs, right.
So for each network that we have
a proposal to we'll we'll start
like that. And then we'll do dot
push proposal, id.to string, and
then we'll write it back. We'll
do Fs dot right, file sync,
proposals file. JSON does string
phi, proposals, and awesome. And
that's all we need to do. So
let's go ahead and actually run
this. And then I have some
console dot logs in here saying,
Hey, here's what the proposal
state is, is it open? Is it
voting is it canceled, you know,
etc. What the proposal snapshot
is, you know, again, check my
GitHub for that. But what we can
do, now this is done, we can do
yarn, Hardhead node, spin up our
little note here. And all the
contracts are deployed. And then
we'll do yarn, run scripts,
proposed that TS dash dash
network, local host scripts
proposed that TS is not found.
Pro pose, yarn, hard hat, run
scripts, pose IDs, oops, dash
dash network, local hosts. Try
this again. Now you found it.
Yay. Oh, I ran into an issue.
Although description Moviebox
Cannot read property zero of
undefined. Let's see where it
got mad at me. Poser sheet dot
event. It is events, not event
shots again, on the localhost.
There we go running ran into
another issue. Posle already
exists. Okay, so great. So the
proposal already exists, let's
go ahead and just like kill the
node, restart the node, so you
can't have two proposals that
are exactly the same, basically,
right. So we can't do that, we
would need to change the
description or something. So
we're just going to kill the
node and restart. Now we're
going to run this proposal
again. And hopefully this one
should work this time. Community
Property zero of undefined owes
receipt. This needs to be await
because it is a promise, kill
this one more time we run it
once all these get deployed. And
we're gonna go ahead and run
this. Now you can see how much
quicker this is than if you were
to actually send this to a test
net right to an event a lot of
waiting, which is no bueno. And
we run into one more Cannot read
property, push them undefined.
That makes a lot of sense, too.
Because proposals dot JSON as
nothing for chain IDs. So
231337. And we'll put a little
list in here. Right now it's an
empty list. Now we're going to
kill this one more time, kill
it.
And then once this goes, then
we're gonna go ahead and do
this. Perfect. Now we're going
to run this and now it should
save and everything should be
peachy hunky dory. Awesome.
proposal number one store in the
box, we move the blocks. And if
we look at proposal dot JSON, we
now see there's a list of
proposals. And this is the
proposal ID of that one we just
created. Oh, okay, we made a
proposal. Awesome. Nice work,
we'll leave that Node running.
And hopefully we'll just do
things right for the voting. So
let's create this vote script
now. Okay, so now we proposed
it's time to vote, let's do a
little voting. So this is going
to look pretty similar to that
script, we just we just created
right. So we're in New async
function, we'll call this main
proposal index number, and we're
calling this main because we're
going to have the vote function
be a little bit different.
You'll see why. And at the
bottom, of course, we're going
to do main index dot then
process dot exit zero, catch
error arrow function, console
dot error, error, and then
process that exit. One main
index, we're gonna say our index
zero cost index zero. We'll do
like this cost index is your
postal index. So we're gonna get
we're gonna get that bit zero
with index, right, the first
index in our proposals dot JSON.
So whatever is the first one in
this list is what we're gonna
use, right? And that's what we
want right now. There's only one
so it's easy. So we're gonna get
that first one in here. So first
thing we're gonna need to do is
we're gonna need to grab the
list of proposals. So we're
gonna do const proposals equals
JSON dot parse, FS dot read,
file sync proposals file, UTF,
eight. So of course, we're going
to need to import a bunch of
stuff. We're going to import
proposals file from that a slash
a Bernhard config. And then
we're going to do import star as
Fs from us. Great. We have Fs,
we can read stuff, and we can
get those boats. Okay, cool. So
we have a list of proposal IDs.
Now let's get our proposal idea
we'll do const probo. also ID
equals proposals of network dot
config. And then that's not what
we want. We want to actually
import network, import network
from hard hat, network dot
config, that chain ID,
exclamation mark of proposal
index, which for us is going to
be zero, right? We're getting
that first proposal in the list
of proposals. Now we're gonna
choose how we want to vote. So
zero equals against one equals
four, and then two is abstain. I
don't know why you'd ever
abstain abstaining costs gas,
you could just not vote, but
we're gonna say const vote way
and the way we're gonna vote
equals one. And we can also do a
reason. So if we go back to our
governor, there's a couple
different functions we get to do
to vote, there's cast vote,
where we just cast a vote, cast,
vote with reason, and cast vote
with signature where we actually
do a signature. And I asked this
question, Hey, what is cast vote
by sick do on the opens up on
forum, I was like, hey, what's
the what is the purpose of this?
My hunch was that anyone could
then execute this vote on behalf
of me if I didn't send the
transaction. And that's exactly
what it is. This method
implements a meta transaction
and allows a project to
subsidize voting fees, the
voters can generate a signature
for free, and the project can
submit those and pay for the
gas. So this is incredibly
powerful. And this is the
function that allows this, this,
this cast vote by signature is
what allows that snapshot chain
link integration that you know,
hopefully one of you build, but
for us for this, since we're not
implementing these meta
transactions, these off chain
stuff, we're just going to do
cast a vote with reason why
because we want to give it a
reason. That's really it. So
we're gonna say const boat TX
response equals await. Gov nor
dot cast, excuse me, we need to
get the government contract. So
we'll do const. Gov nor equals
await ethers dot get contract.
Gov contract. And then if we
don't have ethers, we should get
ethers. Great. Let's get ethers.
And we'll ignore that. But now
we have the contract. So we'll
do a weight gov dot cast vote
with reason spell this right?
With reason. And we'll say
proposal ID that way. And then
the reason which we don't have a
reason here, so let's make a
reason. Let's say the reason is
reason, equals I like do cha
cha, if you know that film, you
should definitely comment it in
the description. We have a
reason so we're voting for we're
saying yes, we want we do indeed
want you to change the box to
77. And the reason is because I
like a do the Cha Cha makes
perfect sense if you don't think
about and then we'll do a wait,
Kotex response that wait. So I
do some stuff, again, checking
the state of the proposal where
different numbers mean, hey,
it's in process, it's voting,
etc, we could check on that. But
we're gonna skip that for now.
All we're going to do now, now
that we voted, we're going to be
the ones to vote. So we're just
going to once again move the
blocks along. Why because we
want to just get to the end of
that voting period. So we're
gonna do again, if velopment
chains, that includes network
dot name, then we're gonna do a
weight move blocks, voting
period, plus one. So we need to
import a whole bunch of stuff in
here. poses file development,
looks like those got auto
imported, we need to import this
move blocks. So import move
blocks from utils blocks, and
that network is in here. And
then we need voting period from
our helper config. voting
period. Okay, cool. And then
we'll do console dot log, voted,
ready to go. Now the reason that
I checked the proposal state is
because there's this state
function in the governor
contract. So if we look up
state, what this does is it
tells us what the state of the
proposals in right if it's been
executed, return that's been
executed, if it's been canceled,
return has been canceled. You
have the deadline, check to see
if it's active, check to see if
quorum reached all this stuff,
right? And what you're usually
looking for is worm reached and
vote succeeded, right? If both
of these happen, the proposal
state DOT succeeded, right?
Otherwise, it's defeated or it's
not there yet. I believe this is
a one and this is a zero. So if
you were to call that function
and get the state right, now we
should get a zero. Or excuse me,
we should get a one for this
having passed. If you want to do
that as a little extra credit,
feel free to do so. So let's see
if we did this right. Well,
actually, I guess we got to
change this just to vote. But I
just wrapped everything up into
main. So let's see if this
works. Yarn, hard hat run
scripts vote network, local
host. So we should get a little
console dot log at the bottom
that says voted ready to go. So
now we're voting. We didn't just
go to the Arctic Council, we
could do yarn, hard hat console,
dash dash network, local host.
And in here, you can actually
just check the state right in
here. Why not? We'll copy this
line as governor because we
either get contract Governor
contract. Now we can do a wait,
Governor, that's state of go to
the proposals dot JSON, grab
this, paste it in here. And we
get a for the state of this
right now is for I forget what
four means. It's like a proposal
state. The proposal state is
actually in the eye governor so
the interface of the governor We
can see, zero is pending, one is
active, two cancelled, three
defeated, and four have
succeeded. So we are in a
succeeded state, which is really
good. That's exactly what we
want. So let's go ahead and quit
now. Excuse me Ctrl. C, our
proposal is now in a succeeded
state. And we've actually moved
the blocks along the voting
period. So voting is now over
because we cheated. So now let's
go ahead and queue and execute
this to the last bit here. So
this is gonna look real similar
to what we've done already.
Right? Let's minimize this,
export async, function, Q, and
execute. And then at the bottom,
we'll just call queue, and
execute. And I'm just going to
copy paste, but it's that same
syntax here, then process exec
catch, blah, blah, blah, you get
the drill. So in order to queue
and execute, go back to the
governor contract, not the
governor, let's go to the
governor. First thing we're
going to do is call this queue.
Now this Q function is actually
in the governor time lock, which
is in this extensions here. So
we can find the governor Time
Lock controller here, and it
does exactly the same as propose
we take everything that we did
in the proposal, and then we
just queue it like so. So we
pass the exact same values here.
And that's so cute. So what
we're going to do is we're gonna
need to first get those exact
same values, which I told you
we're going to use a few times.
So we're going to import bunk,
new store value, proposal
description of our article
thing, right now that we have
all that stuff, we'll say const
args equals a new store value,
we'll do const box equals await
ethers dot get contract, let's
get that box contract again,
we're gonna have to import
ethers from our hat. And this is
going to be from we're gonna do
TS ignore, then we're once again
code this function call to const
encoded function call equals
Boxtop interface, encode
function data. Once again, we're
gonna do funk is the function we
want to call and args this is
like real similar to the our
proposed bit that we did. And
then we're gonna do content
description hash equals ethers
dot utils that get GAC 256
ethers dot utils, that to you,
TF eight bytes, this will make
sense in a second. We're also
description. So what's our
propose, all we did was pass our
proposal description, however,
it actually gets hashed on
chain, and that's what our view
and execute is gonna be looking
for, it's gonna be looking for
the description hash, instead of
just the pure description,
right, and it's gonna be a
little bit cheaper gas wise,
which is good. So now that we
have the description hash, now
that we have all the same
functions that we did for the
suppose it's time to queue them.
So do cost gov equals await
ethers dot get contract. Gov
contract, console dot log will
say we're queuing and then we'll
do cos Q, dx equals gov dot q.
And we're going to pass the
exact same parameters we did
with the pose except for what
the hash instead of the actual
proposal, so box that address
zero for eath, and pass that
code at function call. And then
the description hash rate. And
then we're going to do oops, is
going to be a weight here. And
then we're gonna do a wait. You
text Oh, wait, one, wait a block
there. And great, then we're all
queued up. Now we still have to
wait that minimum delay, right?
Remember, on our timeline, it's
got this min delay thing. It
says, Hey, once something gets
queued up, you can't just
execute it right away. You gotta
give people time to get out. So
we're going to speed up time
again, we're going to say if
development chains develop l
meant chains that includes and
then it looks like it auto
imported for me development
chains. Yes, it did. Amazing.
That includes network dot name.
Let's just make sure we import
network from Hardhead. That
includes our name, then, of
course, we're going to move
blocks. But we also actually
have to move time here as the
minimum delay is looking for
some time. So let's create a new
util called Move time. Okay,
move time that Yes. And this
util is going to allow us to
move time so you're learning all
the cool stuff. So we'll quickly
write a script to do this
important network from hard hat
export async function move time,
how much time will be a number
of Mount console dot log, moving
time, and let's say await
network dot provider dot send
EVM increase time and then just
by the amount, then we'll just
say console dot log, move
forward, amount seconds, it goes
forward and seconds. Cool. So
now we have this move time
function. That was pretty quick,
right? So first, we're going to
move time and we're gonna move
time by that min delay first,
plus one just to be safe. And
then we're also going to move
blocks. We're gonna do a weight
move time, and then a weight
move blocks. And we'll just move
on block. So got it Import move
blocks from utils. It imports
move time from those utils as
well, time. And then we also
have to import this min delay,
which we get from our helper.
Hardhead config. Great. So we
moved all that stuff. Again, if
this were a real chain, you just
have to wait. But since we're
not a real chain, we can do
whatever we want. Yes, love
doing whatever I want. Now that
it's all cued up, the voters
passed, we're looking spicy.
Let's drive this home. Xe cuting
do a little console dot log
executing the const execute TX
equals await. gov dot execute.
We're going to pass this the
exact same set of things we did
for the Q TX so I'm literally
gonna copy this. paste it down
here. And then we're just going
to do a weight SQ TX dot weight.
We're going to wait one block.
And then the final hour we'll
see if the governance updated
our box contract const box new
value equals await box dot
retrieve. And that will do
console dot log. New box value.
Box new value.to string Oh, so
if we did this right, it's new
box value to be updated. Let's
see if we did it right yarn hard
hat run grips Q and execute now
work localhost. Did we do it
right? Are we successfully done
governance? We did. That's okay.
We're gonna figure out what we
did wrong. Did you mean could
check 256 I spelt some stuff
wrong. It needs to be spelt like
no CK. Just just k. Okay, let's
try again. It failed before it
actually did. I think that's
good. Queuing moving time
provider EVM and crit cuz I
spelt increased time wrong. Oh,
no EVM increase time to just
double check. Make sure I'm
spelling this right T is
actually capital. So I totally
messed up. So it's actually
already been queued. It's been
queued right now on our little
node EVM increased team. So we
can either delete and kind of
restart, or I can just go ahead
and I'm just going to comment
out a bunch of stuff, we're just
going to skip the cueing here.
We're gonna run this one more
time, because it's already been
queued. And now should just
execute, we're gonna move time
again. But that's fine. Oh, my
goodness, we did it. Right. And
then normally, you would just do
it in one script. But this queue
would fail because it was
already queued. Right, you can't
queue twice, move forward. In
time, we move blocks we executed
and we got a new box value
completely using our Dow
completely decentralized voting
completely on chain, no third
party trust going in on here.
There's no voting booth, there's
no you know, spending 1000s of
dollars on staff, everything we
just voted on happened right in
front of our faces. Now, again,
I highly recommend go to my
GitHub repo, you take a look and
you see what's going on here.
Again, if you want to see
JavaScript stuff, feel free to
do some JavaScript stuff. But
this goes over how to just get
clone and get started if you
want to do that as well. But if
you walked with me here, if you
walked through this with me, you
have learned in the absolute
Khan, thank you so much for
being here. And I'll see you
next time.
All right. Now, welcome to the
final section of our course, the
security and auditing section,
this one is going to be a little
bit less coding and a little bit
more explaining. And most of
what we're going to be learning
about here is in this Hardhead
security FCC section. Throughout
this course, we've given you a
couple of tips about different
security features. One, we
talked about reentrancy, we
talked a little bit about Oracle
Tax, and we're going to talk
about those more. And some of
the tools we can use to make our
code more efficient, to look out
for bugs, and to make our code
more secure. So we're gonna go
ahead, we're gonna go over this
hard hat security FCC code base,
and we're going to walk through
it a little bit. So one of the
first things that we're going to
talk about is, what is an audit?
Well, an audit is going to be a
security focused code review,
looking for issues with your
code. So for example, let's say
we have some code that looks
like this, this should be a
little bit familiar, because we
talked about this in one of our
earlier sections with
reentrancy, our code, withdraw,
goes and sends ether and then
updates the balances, this code
is clearly vulnerable to a
reentrancy attack here. And this
is something that an auditor
would catch. Since when we
deploy our code, that code is
immutable. And that code will
always be there, it's really
important to have these security
reviews done before we deploy
our code to a main net, and
before we go live, so if you're
going to deploy some crazy,
massive defy protocol, and
you're gonna have billions of
dollars of people's money locked
into your protocol, you probably
want to make sure that the money
is going to go to the correct
places. So audits are incredibly
important for the lifecycle of
our projects. And we want people
to peer review, we want people
to review our code to make sure
that everything looks good. Now,
when we send our code to audit,
though, we shouldn't just say
hey, here's our code. Can you
check them Make sure it's good.
That's not going to give an
auditor enough information, they
need to be able to very easily
know what your code does, how to
work with it, and what you're
looking for. Because auditors
aren't going to be kind of this,
this failsafe, where if your
code is terrible, they're going
to catch everything. Auditors
are human beings too. They can
miss things as well, auditors.
Also, don't make sure that your
code is bug free. Like I said,
audits are security focused peer
reviews for your codebase. And
when you do send your code to
audit, you want to make sure you
help out your auditors as much
as possible. There's an amazing
tweet thread from Tinto and
previously was an open Zeplin
auditor with a ton of tips and
tricks for working with
auditors, I highly recommend you
pause the video, you click this
link and you read through his
tweets because they are
fantastic. openzeppelin has a
readiness guide to try to help
you make sure that you're even
ready for an audit in the first
place. And we've got a link to
this readiness guide in the
GitHub repository. The summary
of them are to add comments to
your code, use natspec, which we
learned about to document your
functions, document your
functions, test, be ready to
talk to your auditors, and be
prepared to give them plenty of
time. They are literally pouring
themselves over your code for
weeks on end to make sure
there's nothing wrong. If you
rush your auditors, you're gonna
get a rushed audit, and they're
going to miss things. So let's
talk about the auditing process.
In auditing process is going to
look like this. First, they're
going to run your tests. That's
the first step in order is
always going to take and right
there, they're gonna find okay,
do they have enough code
coverage? Is everything passing?
What do the tests do? What is
the optimal functionality, after
an auditor runs tests, they're
going to read specs or run your
docs. And then they're going to
run some fast tools like
Slither, linters and static
analysis. And that's going to be
one of the first things we're
going to talk about slither and
static analysis. So static
analysis is the process of just
running some program to read
over all your code and look for
commonly known bugs. One of the
most popular static analysis
tools is going to be this tool
called Slither. And that's going
to be one of the first things
we're going to do here. So let's
go ahead and open up our VS code
now. And we'll make a new
directory called hardhats
security, FCC. We'll cd into it.
We'll do code period. And we'll
open this up. Now what I want
you to do, instead of starting a
new folder, and everything is
we're going to get clone, my
heart had security FCC. So we'll
do git clone, our net security
FCC space, and then put a period
to clone it into this directory.
And we'll get everything like
this. Now in here, this comes
with a couple of different
contracts for us already, that
each have a different
vulnerability, one of them is
going to be bad RNG. This is a
contract that picks a random
winner of a raffle using block
difficulty and message dot
sender. This isn't truly random,
as the miners can influence the
block dot difficulty, and people
can cancel transactions. And
there's a ton of ton of
different vulnerabilities with
creating randomness in this way.
We also have this liquid pool as
an Oracle, the two most common
types of attacks are reentrancy,
which we've learned about an
Oracle manipulation attacks,
which luckily for you, we've
taught you about decentralized
Oracle's and working with chain
link, which should make you a
lot safer. And especially for
this section, I'm going to harp
on these, please, please,
please, if you taking this
course, please do not make a
protocol that falls victim to
one of these, I will feel like I
have failed you. If you build a
protocol where you use some
centralized oracle that gets
manipulated, or you build a
protocol that has a reentrancy
attack. The tools that I'm going
to show you right here are going
to help you with reentrancy. And
everything I've taught you about
chain link should hopefully
teach you how to not get Oracle
manipulated. So in this contract
here, we're using a liquidity
pool as an Oracle and this is
kind of some advanced defy stuff
here. This is a minimalistic
decentralized exchange example
where people can buy and sell
and swap different assets. Now
using this singular exchange, to
get the swap price is a terrible
idea. Because this is a single
protocol for a single price. The
price from this protocol is a
single centralized location, and
we don't want to get our price
from a single centralized
exchange. We want to get it from
many exchanges. Getting the
price of any asset from a single
decentralized exchange is not
decentralized, is somebody
manipulates the market doing
some crazy advanced defy things
that will ruin the price of your
assets. So getting the price of
your assets from a centralized
location is a terrible idea. We
have a metamorphic proxy here.
The issue here is that it's
initialized double, and we don't
guarantee that the contract has
been initialized. We have a
classic reentrancy issue here.
And then we have and then we
have a vault here where some
password is stored on chain and
we're crossing our fingers that
nobody reads this password to
unlock it. So we're going to run
some static analysis on these
contracts, see if that static
analysis can spot some of the
bad things in here.
To get started, we're going to
use a tool like I said called
slither slither tool was created
by this Crytek team, aka the
trilobites team. Now, trilobites
is one of my absolute favorite
auditors in the space. And I
absolutely love all the tools
that this team puts out, they
put up open source security
tools for any of us to use such
as slitter. Now to get started
with Slither, we actually need
to install Python first. So you
can also run it with Docker. But
I'm going to show you how to how
to work with Python first. So if
you haven't worked with Python,
before, you can come to
python.org/downloads and
download Python right from the
website, you'll know you've done
it right. And you can run python
three dash dash version, like
this. Or if you have an older
version of Python, you can run
Python dash dash version. Once
you install Python, you should
also have this tool called PIP
three installed and you can
check by running PIP three dash
dash version, or PIP dash dash
version. And we also want to
install this sock select package
just in case we're using weird
versions of solidity to install.
So select, we run PIP three,
install sock select, like that.
And then we can do sock, select,
use. And then we can choose the
version of solidity or slither
to work with. Once you have
those tools, you can just run
PIP three install slither
analyzer like so. And you can
install slither into your Python
environment. I'm not going to
run it because already have. You
can also learn how to do this
all with Docker and we'll learn
how to do this with Docker in a
little bit. Now in our package
json, we actually have command
script in our package. JSON for
running Slither, you'll know
you've installed slither
correctly. If you can run
Slither, dash dash help you get
an output like this. Now we can
use slither to run it on our
contracts folder by running this
big command here. So we'll say
Slither. And we want to run it
on dot slash contracts, we need
to tell it that it has some
psaltery mappings, and every
time it sees open Zeppelin, it
should use Node module slash
open Zeppelin and every time it
sees chain link introduced node
modules slash chain link. And
I'm just going to read from our
package json. And we're
excluding a couple of functions
that it runs and excluding
builder ignore, but don't worry
too much about that. We've
actually just run that by first
running yarn to install all of
our packages.
And after we've installed all of
our packages, we can run yarn
Slither. Or you can copy paste
that slither command and run it
directly. Now we'll get this
massive output that looks like
this with some red and some
green. Let's go through what's
actually happening here, the way
that we can read Slither, it'll
list out a number of lines that
have an issue and then a
reference to that issue. And
each one of these is separated
by a new line. So that's a
section that's exception, etc.
So if we get a red here, that
means that there is a high
impact issue that we definitely
should address. And it even
comes with a reference link that
we can copy paste and put into
our browser and see what the
issue is and more information
from the slither tool about what
that issue is and how to correct
it. We can see it catches our
metamorphic contract issue. It
says metamorphic contract is
never initialized. It is used
here in metamorphic dot kill.
The reason that this is a
massive issue, if we go to our
metamorphic contract outsole is
that if we deploy this contract,
somebody else could initialize
this code, become the owner, and
then automatically kill it
before we even have a chance.
This is actually something that
has happened in the past and has
caused a ton of issues. So if we
see red in the terminal, this
means Hey, massive issue, we
should absolutely check it out.
Now there's gonna be a ton of
green in here. These are
detectors that are probably low
impact, and they're probably
okay. And in fact, we can see,
it's even just calling out some
opens up on stuff here, saying,
Hey, we see some inline
assembly. Inline assembly is
kind of scary, maybe don't use
that. So you can think of green
as kind of a warning that
there's a low likelihood that
this will impact anything, but
you might want to check it out,
we get this different versions
of solidity used, which is just
saying, hey, there's a couple
different versions of solidity
that might be something you want
to keep in mind, maybe you
should use the same versions of
solidity. We have this allow old
versions. And this is actually
why throughout this whole
course, we've been using zero
point 8.7 Because zero point 8.4
and zero point 8.7 are
considered more stable versions
of solidity. So if you're using
versions outside of there, so
there will say hey, maybe you
want to work with a different
version. We have some flags in
here about maybe Hey, you should
make a variable constant because
it never changes which is great.
Uses literal with too many
digits saying hey, this Just
kind of hard to read, maybe you
screwed up some of the zeros,
loud old versions. And what's
this reentrancy in ether store
dot withdraw. So just by running
this slither tool, we can catch
a reentrancy vulnerability in
one of our contracts, which is
fantastic. So running the static
analysis caught at least two
huge vulnerabilities in our
metamorphic contract. And in our
reentrancy contract, it didn't
catch the issues involved at
sole liquidity pool, or bad RNG,
though, which is why we don't
only want to rely on slither
because it's not going to catch
everything, but it will catch a
lot of major vulnerabilities. So
that's how we can use Slither,
at least from a middle middle
stack point to get started. So
great, we just learned how to
work with Slither. That's one of
the first tools that are really
fantastic in our audit process.
And that's going to be
considered a fast tool for
static analysis, running tests,
linters, etc, are also types of
static analysis.
After we run a tool like that,
we enter some manual analysis
where we walk through the code
ourselves manually, and maybe we
do it in tangent with running
some slower tools, like a kitna
Manta Corp, and other symbolic
execution tools. Symbolic
Execution is where we simulate
executing transactions on the
blockchain. And one of these
symbolic execution tools that
we're going to work with is this
a kidmin tool. Again, this is a
trail of bits tool for doing
something called fuzz testing.
Now in programming, fuzzing or
fuzz testing is an automated
software testing technique that
involves providing invalid
unexpected or random data as
inputs to a computer program. In
a lot of our code, oftentimes,
we're going to get people
interacting with them in ways
that we will never think about.
So we want to be able to provide
random data and random
information to our test to see
if something weird happens that
we weren't expecting. So we can
actually build our own fuzz
tests in our hard hat projects
and run these fuzz tests, I've
actually created a sample of
fuzz tests, we write our fuzz
tests in solidity, actually, as
opposed to writing our tests in
JavaScript. So let's say for
example, we've built this vault
contract. And we think that at
first glance, hey, nobody should
ever be able to know the
password, and no one should ever
be able to unlock this contract.
Which obviously, we know is
ridiculous, because we know that
anybody can read anything in a
storage variable. So we know
that this should fail, but it
might be hard to write a test.
To catch that this actually
would fail. A good approach to
testing this would be to just
send a ton of random bytes 32
objects to this unlock function
to see if we can unlock it. We
can write a fuzz test to do
exactly that. So in my vault,
fuzz test dot Sol, we're
importing vault outsole. And so
we're saying vault fuzz test is
vault and we have a password of
123, ASD 123. And now we have a
function called a kid and a test
find password, where it's going
to send a ton of random data
into vault to try to make s
locked equal false. So we just
say s locked equals true here,
and our first test will try to
make s locked equals false. Now
we could install just the kitna,
but at this point, it's a good
idea to bring up our the
security toolbox from trail of
bits. So trail of bits has a
package called the eath security
toolbox, which has all their
security tools in one single
container kitna, Ethan o Manta
core, slither, rattle, and not
so smart contracts, it has all
these in the same exact package.
Now to work with this toolbox.
We're gonna need Docker
installed. So we're gonna do a
little bit of installation here.
And again, sometimes this can be
the hardest part of the course
is just installing these
packages. So we've left a link
to Doc's dot docker.com, get
Docker to install Docker, to
actually work with these tools,
you're just going to come you're
going to click whichever one of
these is appropriate for you to
install Docker, once we have
Docker installed, we can run the
E security toolbox by pulling it
down from the Docker equivalent
of GitHub. And we're going to
use a whole bunch of Docker
commands that I'm not going to
explain here because this isn't
a Docker course, if you're
looking to get into the security
stuff, I would definitely
recommend reading up on all
these commands afterwards. And
we're going to leave a ton of
links for you to learn more. And
in the package that JSON
associated with this lesson. We
even have the command to get set
up right in here. So we can just
run yarn toolbox, which will run
our Docker command like this. So
I'm just going to run yarn
toolbox. And if you get
something like this saying
cannot connect to the Docker
daemon is the Docker daemon
running, because I need to have
my Docker daemon running. Since
I installed Docker desktop. I
need to have my Docker engine
started and running for it to
actually be working. Again to
work with this. There's a lot of
Docker setup and configuration
that needs to happen, which I'm
going to leave a ton of
instructions on how to get
started with Docker. Once we
have Docker setup. Now we can
run yarn toolbox, which will
stick us into a new shell to
work with any of these tools
that trilobites has Out of the
box. Now our vault fuzz test
comes with a config as well.
This is in a Yamo file with all
our arguments for running a
kidnap. So it has a test limit,
which is how many different
runs, we should do a time delay,
block delay. And then of course,
some re mappings in here. This
darker shell will already have
the security tools already
installed like the Kidner test.
So we'll run a kinah test on SRC
slash contracts slash test slash
fuzzing slash fault fuzz test
dot Sol dash dash contract will
be vault fuzz test, dash dash
config will be SRC slash
contracts slash test slash
buzzing slash config dot Yamo.
And we'll go ahead and we'll hit
enter here, and it'll say
analyzing contract, it'll give
us an output like this, it will
give us an output that looks
like this. What it's saying is
it found a use case where it
could make s locked equals
false. And the use case was 123,
ASD 123. So when what seemed
like almost seconds, it found
the password to unlock our
contract. And this is why
running a fuzz tester can be so
powerful, we thought our
contract was secure, but it
immediately found the password,
which means anybody else could
immediately find the password.
And this would be an indicator
that what we're doing there is
not a good setup. So we'll hit
CTRL C to escape. And to leave
our Docker setup here,
we'll just write exit. Now
again, I'm going to leave a ton
of links to work with a
kidnapper and work with this
fuzz tester in the GitHub repo
associated with this lesson, so
that you can go ahead and learn
more. Now, if you take anything
away from this whole section, it
should be this right here. The
two most common tasks are
reentrant. See, and Oracle
manipulation. So if you're not
going to be an auditor, and you
just want to deploy things to
main net, always, always before
you deploy anything, the
absolute minimum that you should
be doing is always running
Slither. And then looking
manually for Oracle manipulation
and reentrancy attacks. If you
see in your code that you're
getting pricing information.
Price is a piece of data that we
as humans have assigned to
something if you're getting
pricing information from a
centralized location, rethink
that scenario, rethink what
you're doing there. If you're
getting a random number, if
you're doing any type of
automation from a centralized
location, rethink it and change
your strategy. The chain link
Oracle network has been created
for a reason to prevent getting
hacked like this. So please keep
these in mind before you deploy
anything to main that with any
type of security guarantees.
Okay, great. So we've learned
about the fast tools, we've
learned about some of the slow
tools. We didn't look into Manta
Corp or Mythix. But these are
also tools that you can use
Manta Corp is going to be
another tool from the trilobites
team. And Mythix is actually a
smart contract security service
from the consensus team, you
basically send a bot that they
have running in the cloud your
contracts and will do some
automated process to check for
security vulnerabilities. This
is a paid service. But if you're
going to be deploying a protocol
that's worth millions of
dollars, spending a few $1,000.
Spending a few $1,000 to make
sure it actually does. What it
says is going to do correctly is
definitely something that you
want to invest in. After you run
through this whole process. You
the smart contract developers
and the auditors should discuss
their findings. And if there's
any issues, repeat the steps,
repeat all the steps again after
changes are made. So this audit
process and making sure your
contracts are secure is a long
process. And then afterwards, an
auditor will finally write your
report with all security
vulnerabilities and everything
that they found in your
contracts. Typically, you'll
organize reports in a chart
that'll look something like
this, you'll label issues that
have a high chance of happening
and have a high impact as
critical things that have a high
impact, but a low likelihood as
medium, and etc. I'm also going
to leave some examples two
audits that have been done in
the past so that you can take a
look at them. And you can see
what a full audit looks like on
certain code. We'll be looking
at openzeppelin sigma prime, and
trilobites, because these are
three of what I think are some
of the best auditors in the
space. Now in the GitHub repo.
We also have a ton of other
tools that you can use Mythix,
mithril ethers play and
consensus security tools. If you
want to learn more about
security and auditing, I highly
recommend that after this course
you play the Ethernet game and
damn vulnerable Defy. These are
two games that will teach you a
ton about security. And we'll
test the chops and we'll test
everything that you've learned
in this course. There's also a
couple of security focused blogs
that I really like. One of them
in particular is wrecked dot
news. They keep a running list
of some of the largest hacks
that have ever happened in the
space and then retrospectives on
why those actually happened. And
they usually make it very
entertaining as well. We have
some articles in here as well.
One of the best places to look
at is this known attacks section
where they talk Talk about
reentrancy, Oracle manipulation,
front running and a ton of other
attacks that you should
absolutely be aware of when
writing your smart contracts,
we're not going to go over them
here because they do a great job
in these resources explaining
them, you should also check out
this article because I helped
write it. So definitely check
that out. And then we've got a
list to even more sections. So
this is going to be a living
section here. So please feel
free. If you find more things in
the future, please feel free to
make pull requests and update
this repository so that other
people can learn and know more
about security and auditing and
have contract examples on what
bad code looks like and how to
actually catch them. Even though
this was one of our quickest
sections. From a video
standpoint, this actually is
going to be one of the longest
sections of your career.
Security is something that is
always going to be on your mind.
And there's always going to be
new tools to help with security.
new things to think about. So
even though we went through this
very quickly, I would 100% want
you to pause this video, and
work with and try out some of
the tools we tried here. And
then maybe even try coming up
with your own vulnerabilities as
well. And with that being said,
you have just finished the last
section of this massive master
course on learning smart
contracts, solidity, web three
and blockchain development,
you should be incredibly proud
of yourself. Congratulations, I
and the web three community as a
whole want to congratulate you
for completing this absolutely
monstrosity of a tutorial, you
have done an amazing job to get
this far. And to watch me
talking to you right now. And if
you haven't finished the course,
go back and finish it before
coming here. We have learned so
much on this journey. And I can
say from the bottom of my soul
that I am so glad to have you in
the web three space, smart
contract space, the blockchain
space, the cryptocurrency space,
we are so excited that you're
here. I'm really looking forward
to seeing you in the web three
in the blockchain community. Now
a lot of people ask, Well, where
do I go? Now, I didn't have all
this newfound knowledge. I'm
armed with the intelligence of
the web three developer space.
Well, I've left some links in
the GitHub repository to lead
you to those next steps. But the
biggest thing that you can do
for yourself right now is go
take what you've learned, and
apply it somewhere. This is
going to be probably the most
thorough course you will ever go
through in this space. And you
can go tutorial to tutorial and
boot camp to bootcamp all you
want. But at some point, you
have to make that leap, and you
have to dive in. And that's
where the majority of the growth
is going to be anyways. So if
you're here, wondering where to
go next, go join a hackathon. Go
start jumping into issues on
GitHub repos, go start applying
for grants, go start applying
for jobs and say, I took
Patrick's massive course. Here's
my GitHub repo, work on a
personal project, work on
somebody else's project. Take
this knowledge and apply it, the
challenges that you'll run into
and the challenges that you'll
face. Really trying to do
something without me hand
holding you is where you're
going to learn 10 times as much
as what you've learned here.
I've walked through as deep down
this rabbit hole as I can take
you. Now it's up to you to go
out and do something with it. So
thank you, everybody who helped
me create this course. Thank you
for taking this course. And I'm
so excited to see you in the
community and see what you build
and see what we can create with
this technology.